if you want to learn about computer
science and the Art of programming this
course is where to start cs50 is
considered by many to be one of the best
computer science courses in the world
this is a Harvard University course
taught by Dr David Malin and we are
proud to bring it to the freeco camp
YouTube channel throughout a series of
lectures Dr Malin will teach you how to
think algorithmically and solve problems
efficiently and make sure to check the
description for a lot of extra resources
that go along with the course
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Harvard University's introduction to the
intellectual Enterprises of computer
science and the Art of programming back
here on campus in beautiful Sanders
Theater for the first time in quite a
while so welcome to the class my name is
David Mann again
foreign
and I took this class myself some time
ago but almost didn't it was it was
sophomore fall and I was sitting in on
the class and I was a little curious but
I didn't really feel like the fields for
me I was definitely a computer person
but computer science felt like something
all together and I only got up the nerve
to take the class ultimately because the
professor at the time Brian Carnahan
allowed me to take the class pass fail
initially and that is what made all the
difference I quickly found that computer
science is not just about programming
and working in isolation on your
computer it's really about problem
solving more generally and there was
something about homework frankly that
was like actually fun for perhaps the
first time in what 19 years and there
was something about this ability that I
discovered along with all of my
classmates to actually create something
and bring a computer to life to solve a
problem and sort of bring to bear
something that I'd been using every day
but didn't really know how to harness
that's been gratifying ever since and
definitely challenging and frustrating
like to these to this day all these
years later you're going to run up
against mistakes otherwise known as bugs
and programming that just drive you nuts
and you feel like you've hit a wall but
the trick really is to give it enough
time to take a step back take a break
when you need to and there's nothing
better I dare say than that sense of
gratification and pride really when you
get something to work and in a class
like this present ultimately a term's
end something like your very own final
project now this isn't to say that I
took to it 100 perfectly in fact just
this uh this past week I I looked in my
old cs50 binder which I still have from
some 25 years ago and took a photo of
what was apparently the very first
program that I wrote and submitted and
quickly received minus two points on but
this is a program that we'll soon see in
the coming days that does something
quite simply like print hello cs50 in
this case to the screen and to be fair I
technically hadn't really followed the
directions which is why I lost those
couple of points but if you just look at
this especially if you've never
programmed before you might have heard
about programming languages but you've
never typed something like this out
undoubtedly it's going to look cryptic
but I'm unlike human languages frankly
which were a lot more sophisticated a
lot more vocabulary a lot more
grammatical rules programming once you
start to wrap your mind around what it
is and how it works and what these
various languages are it's so easy
you'll see after a few months of a class
like this to start teaching yourself
subsequently other languages as they may
come in the coming years as well so what
ultimately matters in this particular
course is not so much where you end up
relative to your classmates but where
you end up relative to yourself when you
began and indeed you'll begin today and
the only experience that matters
ultimately in this class is your own and
so consider where you are today consider
perhaps just how cryptic something like
that looked a few seconds ago and take
comfort in knowing just some months from
now all of that will be within your own
grasp and if you're thinking that okay
surely the person in front of me to the
left to the right behind me knows more
than me that's statistically not the
case two-thirds of cs50 students have
never taken a CS course before which is
to say you're in very good company any
throughout this whole term
so then what is computer science I claim
that it's problem solving and the upside
of that is that problem solving is
something we sort of do all the time but
a computer science class learning to
program I think kind of cleans up your
thoughts it helps you learn how to think
more methodically more carefully more
correctly more precisely because
honestly the computer is not going to do
what you want unless you are correct and
precise and methodical and so as such
there's these sort of fringe benefits of
just wanting to think like a computer
scientist and a programmer and it
doesn't take all that much to start
doing so this for instance is perhaps
the simplest picture of computer science
sure but really problem solving in
general problems are all about taking
input like the problem you want to solve
you want to get the solution AKA output
and so something interesting has got to
be happening in here in here when you're
trying to get from those inputs to
outputs now in the world of computers
specifically we need to decide in
advance how we represent these inputs
and outputs we all just need to decide
uh whether it's Macs or PCS or phones or
something else that we're all going to
speak some common language irrespective
of our human languages as well and you
may very well know that computers tend
to speak only what language so to speak
assembly one but binary two might be
your go-to in binary by implying two
means that the world of computers has
just two digits at its disposal zero and
one and indeed we humans have many more
than that certainly not just zeros and
ones alone but a computer indeed only
has zeros and ones and yet somehow they
can do so much they can crunch numbers
in Excel send text messages create
images and and artwork and movies and
more and so how do you get from
something as simple as a few zeros a few
ones to all of the stuff that we're
doing today in our pockets and laptops
and desktops well it turns out that we
can start quite simply if a computer
were to want to do something as simple
as count well what could it do well in
our human world we might count doing
this like one two three four five using
so-called unary notation literally the
digits on your fingers where one finger
represents one person in the room if I'm
for instance taking attendance now we
humans would typically actually count
one two three four five six and we'd go
past just those five digits and count
much higher using zeros through nine
lines but computers somehow only have
these zeros and ones so if a computer
only somehow speaks binary zeros and
ones how does it even count past the
number one well here are three zeros of
course and if you translate this number
in binary zero zero zero to a more
familiar number in decimal we would just
call this zero enough said if we were to
represent with a computer the number one
it would actually be zero zero one which
not surprisingly is exactly the same as
we might do in our human world but we
might not bother writing out the two
zeros at the beginning but a computer
now if it wants to count as high as two
it doesn't have the digit two and so it
has to use a different pattern of zeros
and ones and that happens to be zero one
zero so this is not ten with a zero in
front of it it's indeed zero one zero in
the context of binary and if we want to
count higher now than two we're going to
have to tweak these zeros and ones
further to get three and then if we want
four or five or six or seven we're just
kind of toggling these zeros and ones a
Ka bits for binary digits that represent
via these different patterns different
numbers that you and I as humans know of
course as the so-called Decimal System
zero through nine deck implying ten ten
digits those zeros through nine so why
that particular pattern and why these
particular zeros and ones well it turns
out that representing one thing or the
other is just really simple for a
computer why at the end of the day
they're powered by electricity and it's
a really simple thing to just either
store some electricity or don't store
some electricity like that's as simple
as the world can get on or off one or
zero so to speak so in fact inside of a
computer a phone anything these days
that's electronic pretty much is some
number of switches otherwise known as
transistors and they're tiny you've got
thousands millions of them in your Mac
or PC or phone these days and these are
just tiny little switches that can get
turned on and off and by turning those
things on and off in patterns a computer
can count from zero on up to seven and
even higher than that and so these
switches really you can think of being
is like switches like this let me just
borrow one of our little stage lights
here here's a light bulb it's currently
off and so I could just think of this as
representing in my laptop a transistor a
switch representing zero but if I allow
some electricity to flow now I in fact
have a one well how do I count higher
than one I of course need another light
bulb so let me grab another one here and
if I put it in that same kind of pattern
I don't want to just do this that's sort
of the old finger counting way of unary
just one two I want to actually take
into account the pattern of these things
being on and off so if this was one a
moment ago what I think I did earlier
was I turned it off and let the next one
over be on AKA zero one zero and let me
get us a third bit if you will and that
feels like enough here is that same
pattern now starting at the beginning
with three so here is zero zero zero
here is zero zero one here is zero one
zero AKA in our human world of decimal
two and then we could of course keep
counting further this now would be three
and dot dot dot if this other bulb now
goes on and that switch is turned and
all three stay on this again was what
number
okay so seven so it's just as simple
relatively as that if you will but how
is it that these patterns came to be
well these patterns actually follow
something very familiar you and I don't
really think about it at this level
anymore because we've probably been
doing math and numbers since grade
school or whatnot but if we consider
something in decimal like the number 123
I immediately jumped to that this looks
like 123 in decimal but why it's really
just three symbols a one a two with a
bit of curve a three with a couple of
curves that you and I know instinctively
just assign meaning to but if we do
rewind a few years that is 123 because
you're assigning meaning to each of
these columns the three is in the
so-called ones place the two
is in the so-called tens place and the
one is in the so-called hundreds place
and then the math ensues quickly in your
head this is technically 100 times one
plus ten times two plus one times three
AKA 100 plus 20 plus three and there we
get the sort of mathematical notion we
know is 123.
well nicely enough in binary it's
actually the same thing it's just these
columns mean a little something
different if you use three digits in
decimal and you have the ones place the
tens place and the hundreds place well
why was that 10 110 and 100 they're
technically just powers of ten so 10 to
the zero ten to the one ten to the 2 why
10 Decimal System deck meaning ten you
have eight and ten digits zero through
nine in the binary system if you're
going to use three digits just change
the bases if you're using only what
zeros and ones so now it's powers of two
two to the zero two to the one two to
the two AKA one and two and four
respectively and if you keep going it's
going to be eights columns 16's column
32 64 and so forth
so why did we get these patterns that we
did here's your zero zero zero because
it's four times zero two times zero one
times zero obviously zero this is why we
got the decimal number one in binary
this is why we got the number two in
binary because it's four times zero plus
two times one plus one times zero and
now three and now four and now five and
now six and now seven and of course if
you wanted to count as high as eight to
be clear like what do you have to do
what does a computer need to do to count
even higher than seven
add a bit add another light bulb another
switch and indeed computers have
standardized just how many zeros and
ones or bits or switches they throw at
these kinds of problems and in fact most
computers would typically use at least
eight at a time and even if you're on
accounting as high as three or seven you
would still use eight and have a whole
bunch of zeros but that's okay because
the computers these days certainly have
so many more thousands millions of
transistors and switches that that's
quite okay
all right so if with that said if we can
now count as high as seven or frankly as
high as we want that only seems to make
computers useful for things like Excel
like number crunching but computers of
course let you send text messages write
documents and so much more so how would
a computer represent something like a
letter like the letter A of the English
alphabet
if at the end of the day all they have
is switches
and he thoughts yeah
okay so we could represent letters using
numbers okay so give me what's a
proposal what number should represent
what
perfect yeah we just all have to agree
somehow that one number is going to
represent one letter so one is a two is
B three is C uh Z is 26 and so forth
maybe we can even take into account
uppercase and lowercase we just have to
agree and sort of write it down in some
global standard and humans indeed did
just that they didn't use one two three
turns out they started a little higher
up capital A has been standardized as
the number 65 and capital B has been
standardized as the number 66 and you
can kind of imagine how it goes up from
there and that's because
whatever you're representing ultimately
can only be stored at the end of the day
as zeros and ones and so some humans in
a room before decided that capital A
shall be 65 or really this pattern of
zeros and ones inside of every computer
in the world zero one zero zero zero
zero zero one so if that pattern of
zeros and ones if it appears in a
computer it might be interpreted then as
indeed a capital letter a eight of those
bits at a time but I worry just to be
clear we might have now created a
problem it might seem if I play this
naively that okay how do I now actually
do math with the number 65 if now Excel
display is 65 is an a let alone B's and
C's so how might a computer do as you've
proposed have this mapping from numbers
to letters but still support numbers
feels like we've given something up yeah
by having a prefixed
okay so we could perhaps have some kind
of prefix like some pattern of zeros and
ones I like this that rep that indicates
to the computer here comes another
pattern that represents a letter here
comes another pattern that represents a
one a number or a letter so not bad I
like that other thoughts
how might a computer distinguish these
two yeah
indeed and that's spot on nothing wrong
with what you suggested but the world
generally does just that the reason we
have all of these different file formats
in the world like uh JPEG and Jif and
pings and
worddocuments.d-o-s-c-x and Excel files
and so forth is because a bunch of
humans got in a room and decided Well in
the context of this type of file or
really more specifically in the context
of this type of program Excel versus
Photoshop versus Google Docs or the like
we shall interpret any patterns of zeros
and ones as being maybe numbers for
Excel maybe letters in like a text
messaging program or Google Docs or
maybe even colors of the rainbow in
something like Photoshop and more so
it's context dependent and we'll see
when we ourselves start programming you
the programmer will ultimately provide
some hints to the computer that tells
the computer interpret it as follows so
similar in spirit to that but not quite
as standardized with these prefixes so
this system here actually has a name
ASCII the American Standard code for
information interchange and indeed it
began here in the U.S and that's why
it's actually a little biased toward A's
through Z's and a bit of punctuation as
well and that quickly became a problem
but if we start simply now in English
the mapping itself is fairly
straightforward so if a is 65 B is 66
and dot dot dot suppose that you
received a text message an email from a
friend and underneath the hood so to
speak if you kind of looked inside the
computer what you technically received
in this text or this email happened to
be the numbers 72 73 33
or really the underlying pattern of
zeros and ones what might your friend
have sent you as a message if it's 72 73
. hey close
hi it's indeed High Why well apparently
according to this little cheat sheet H
is 72 I is 73 it's not obvious from this
chart what the 33 is but indeed this
pattern represents high and anyone want
to guess or if you know what 33 is
exclamation point and this is frankly
not the kind of thing most people know
but it's easily accessible by a nice
user-friendly chart like this so this is
an ASCII chart when I said that we just
need to write down this mapping earlier
this is what people did they wrote it
down in a book or in a chart and for
instance here is our 72 for eight here
is our 73 for I and here is our 7 or 33
for exclamation points and computers Max
PCS iPhones Android devices just know
this mapping by heart if you will
they've been designed to understand
those letters so here I might have
received hi technically what I've
received is these patterns of zeros and
ones but it's important to note that
when you get these patterns of zeros and
ones in any format be it email or text
or a file they do tend to come in
standard lengths with a certain number
of zeros and ones all together and this
happens to be eight plus eight plus
eight so just to get the message Hi
exclamation point you would have
received at least it would seem some 24
bits but frankly bits are so tiny
literally and mathematically that we
don't tend to think or talk generally in
terms of bits you're probably more
familiar with bytes
b-y-t-e-s is a bite is a bite is a bite
a bite is just eight Bits And even those
frankly aren't that useful if we do out
the math how high can you count if you
have eight bits anyone know
say again
uh higher than that unless you want to
go negative that's that's fine
256 technically 255 long story short if
we actually got into the weeds of all of
these zeros and ones and we figured out
what one one one one one one one one one
one mathematically adds up to in decimal
it would indeed be 255 or less if you
want to represent negative numbers as
well so this is useful because now we
can speak not just in terms of bytes but
if the files are bigger kilobytes is
thousands of bytes megabytes is millions
of bytes gigabytes is billions of bytes
terabytes are trillions of bytes and so
forth
we have a vocabulary for these
increasingly large quantities of data
the problem is that if you're using
ASCII and therefore eight bits or one
byte per character
and originally only seven you can only
represent 255 characters and that's
actually five or 256 total characters
including zero and that's fine if you're
using literally English in this case
plus a bunch of punctuation but there's
many human languages in the world that
need many more symbols and therefore
many more bits so thankfully the world
decided that will indeed support not
just the U.S English keyboard but all of
the accented characters that you might
want for some languages and Heck if we
use enough bits zeros and ones not only
can we represent all human languages in
written form as well as some emotions
along the way we can capture the latter
with these things called emojis and
indeed these are very much in Vogue
these days you probably send them or
receive many of these things any given
day these are just characters like
letters of an alphabet patterns of zeros
and ones that you're receiving that the
world has also standardized for instance
there are certain emojis that are
represented with certain patterns of
bits and when you receive them your
phone your laptop your desktop displays
them as such and this newer standard is
called Unicode so it's a superset of
what we call ASCII and unicode is just a
mapping of many more numbers to many
more letters or characters more
generally that might use eight bits for
backwards compatibility with the old way
of doing things with ASCII but they
might also use 16 Bits And if you have
16 bits you can actually represent more
than 65 000 possible letters and that's
getting up there and heck Unicode might
even use
32-bits to represent letters and numbers
and punctuation symbols and emojis and
that would give you up to 4 billion
possibilities and I dare say one of the
reasons we see so many emojis these days
is we have so much room I mean there's
got room for billions more literally so
in fact just as a little bit of trivia
has anyone ever received this decimal
number or if you prefer binary now has
anyone ever received this pattern of
zeros and ones on your phone in a text
or an email perhaps this past year
well if you actually look this up this
esoteric uh sequence of zeros and ones
happens to represent uh faced with
medical mask and notice that if you've
got an iPhone or an Android device you
might be seeing different things in fact
this is the Android version of this most
recently this is the iOS version of it
most recently and there's Bunches of
other interpretations by other companies
as well
so Unicode as a Consortium if you will
has standardized the descriptions of
what these things are but the companies
themselves
manufacturers out there have generally
interpreted mgc fit and this can lead to
some human uh miscommunications in fact
for like literally embarrassingly like a
year or two I started being in a habit
of using the Emoji that kind of looks
like this because I thought it was like
happy face or whatever I didn't realize
this is the emoji for hug because
whatever device I was using sort of
looked like this not like this and
that's because of their interpretation
of the data this has happened too when
what was a gun became a a water pistol
in some manufacturer's eyes and so it's
an interesting dichotomy between
what information we all want to
represent and how we choose ultimately
to represent it
questions then on these representations
of formats be it numbers or letters or
soon more yeah
and sorry why is what so popular
yeah so we'll come back to this in a few
weeks in fact there are other ways to
represent numbers binary is one decimal
is another unary is another and
hexadecimal is yet a fourth that uses 16
total digits literally zero through nine
plus a b c d e f and somehow you can
similarly count even higher with those
uh we'll see in a few weeks why this is
uh compelling but hexadecimal long story
short uses four bits per digit and so
four bits if you have two digits in HEX
that gives you eight and it's just a
very convenient unit of measure and it's
also human convention in the world of
like files and other things but we'll
come back to that soon other questions
through the lights on the stage
supposedly say anything well if we had
thought in advance to use maybe 64 light
bulbs that would seem to give us uh
eight total bites on stage eight times
uh eight giving us just that maybe
good question other questions on zeros
and ones
it's a little bright in here
no oh yes
where everyone's pointing somewhere
specific
there we go sorry very bright in this
corner
oh sure and we'll come back to this in
some form in the coming days too at a
slower Pace too we have with eight bits
two possible values for the first and
then two for the next two for the next
and so forth so that's two times two
times two that's two to the eighth power
total which means you can have 256 total
possible patterns of zeros and ones but
as we'll see soon computer scientists
programmers software often starts
counting at zero by convention and if
you use one of those patterns zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero to
represent the decimal number we know is
zero you only have 255 other patterns
left to count as high as therefore 255.
that's all good question
all right so what then might we have
besides uh these emojis and letters and
numbers well we of course have things
like colors and programs like Photoshop
and pictures and photos well let me ask
the question again how might a computer
do you think knowing what you know now
represents something like a color
like what are our options if all we've
got are zeros and ones and switches yeah
RGB when uh RGB indeed is This Acronym
that represents some amount of red and
some amount of green and blue and indeed
computers can represent Colors by just
doing that remembering for instance this
dot this yellow dot on the screen that
might be part of any of those emojis
these days well that's some amount of
red some amount of green some amount of
blue and if you sort of mix those colors
together we can indeed get a very
specific one and we'll see in just a
moment just that
so indeed earlier on did humans only use
seven bits total and it was only once
they decided Well let's add an eighth
bit that they got extended ASCII and
that was initially in part A solution to
the same problem of not having enough
room if you will in those patterns of
zeros and ones to represent all of the
characters that you might want but even
that wasn't enough and that's why we've
now gone up to 16 and 32 and long past
seven so if we come back now to this one
particular color RGB was proposed as a
scheme but how might this work well
consider for instance this if we do
indeed decide as a group to represent
any color of the rainbow with some
mixture of some red some green and some
blue we have to decide how to represent
the amount of red and green and blue
well it turns out if all we have are
zeros and ones Ergo numbers let's do
just that for instance suppose a
computer we're using these three numbers
72 73 33 no longer in the context of an
email or a 10 text message but now in
the context of something like Photoshop
a program for editing and creating
graphical files maybe this first number
could be interpreted as representing
some amount of red green and blue
respectively and that's exactly what
happens you can think of the first digit
as red second is Green Third is blue and
so ultimately when you combine that
amount of red that amount of green that
amount of blue it turns out it's going
to resemble this shade of yellow and
indeed you can come up with numbers
between 0 and 255 for each of those
colors to mix any other color that you
might want and you can actually see this
in practice even though our screens
admittedly are getting really good on
our phones and laptops such that you
barely see the dots they are there you
might have heard the term pixel before
pixel is just a DOT on the screen and
you've got thousands millions of them
these days horizontally and vertically
and if I take even this Emoji which
again happens to be one company's
interpretation of faced with medical
mask and zoom in in a bit maybe zoom in
a bit more you can actually start to see
these pixels things get pixelated
because what you're seeing is each of
the individual dots that compose this
particular image and apparently each of
these individual dots are probably using
24 bits eight bits for red 8 Bits for
green eight bits for blue in some
pattern and this program or some other
like Photoshop is interpreting one
pattern it's white or yellow or black or
some brown in between and so if you look
sort of awkwardly but up close to your
phone or your laptop or maybe your TV
you can see exactly this too
all right well what about things that we
also watch every day on YouTube or the
like things like videos how would a
computer knowing what we know now
represents something like a video
how might you represent a video using
only zeros and ones yeah
exactly and to summarize what video
really adds is just some notion of time
it's not just one image it's not just
one letter or number it's presumably
some kind of sequence because time is
passing and so with a whole bunch of
images maybe 24 maybe 30 per second if
you fly them by the human's eyes we can
interpret them using our eyes and brain
that there is now movement and therefore
video and similarly with audio or music
if we just came up with some convention
for representing those same notes on a
musical instrument could we have the
computer synthesize them too and this
might be actually pretty familiar let me
pull up a quick video here which happens
to be an old school version of this same
idea you might remember from childhood
foreign
[Music]
so granted that particular video is an
actual video of a paper-based animation
but indeed that's really all you need is
some sequence of these uh these images
which themselves of course are just
zeros and ones because they're just this
grid of these pixels or dots now
something like musical notes like these
those of you who are musicians might
just naturally play these on physical
devices but computers can certainly
represent those sounds too and for
instance a popular format for audio is
called midi and midi might just
represent each note that you saw a
moment ago essentially as a sequence of
numbers but more generally you might
think about music as having notes for
instance a through G maybe some flats
and some Sharps you might have the
duration like how long is the note being
heard or played on a piano or some other
device and then just the volume like how
hard does the human in the real world
press down on that key and therefore how
loud is that sound it would seem that
just remembering little details like
that quantitatively we can then
represent really all of these these
otherwise anal Vlog uh human realities
so that then is really a laundry list of
ways that we can just represent
information again computers or digital
have all these different formats but at
the end of the day and as fancy as those
devices and yours are it's just zeros
and ones tiny little switches or light
bulbs if you will represented in some
way and it's up to the software that you
and I and others write to use those
zeros and ones in ways we want to get
the computers to do something more
powerfully questions then on this
representation of information which I
dare say is ultimately what problem
solving is all about taking in
information and producing new via some
process in between
any questions out there
uh yeah and back
so a really good question there are many
other file formats out there you allude
to MP4 for video and more generally
these are these things called codex and
containers it's not quite as simple when
using larger files for instance in more
modern formats that a video is just a
sequence of images for instance why if
you stored that many images for like a
Hollywood movie like 24 or 30 of them
per second that's a huge number of
images and if you've ever taken phone
photos on your phone you might know how
many megabytes or larger even individual
photographs might be so humans have
developed over the years uh fancier
software that uses much more math to
represent the same information more
minimally just using somehow shorter
patterns of zeros and ones than our most
simplistic representation here and they
use what might be called compression if
you've ever used a zip file or something
else somehow your computer is using
fewer zeros in one strip represent the
same amount of information ideally
without losing any information and in
the world of multimedia which we'll
touch on a little bit in a few weeks
there are both lossy and lossless
formats out there lost list means you
lose no information whatsoever but more
commonly as you're alluding to one is
lossy compression l-o-s-s-y where you're
actually throwing away some amount of
quality you're getting a sum amount of
pixelation that might not look perfect
to the human but heck it's a lot cheaper
and a lot easier to distribute and in
the world of multimedia you have
containers like Quicktime and other MPEG
containers that can combine different
formats of video different formats of
audio in one file but there too do
designers have discretion so more in a
few weeks two other questions then on
information
here as well yeah
exactly I mean back in the day you might
have heard of the expression of vacuum
tube which is like some physically large
device
um that might have only stored some zero
or one
um yes it is the miniaturization of
Hardware these days that has allowed us
to store as many and many more zeros and
ones much more closely together and as
we've built more fancy machines that can
sort of Design This Hardware at an even
smaller scale we're just packing more
and more into these devices but there
too is a trade-off for instance you
might know by using your phone or your
laptop for quite a while maybe on your
lap starts to get warm and so there are
these literal physical side effects of
this where now some of our devices run
hot and this is why like a data center
in the real world might need more air
conditioning than a typical place
because there are these physical
artifacts as well and in fact if you'd
like to see one of the earliest
computers from decades ago across the
river here in now Austin in the new
engineering building is the Harvard mark
one computer that will will give you a
much big a better mental model of just
that well if we come back now to this
first picture being computer science or
really problem solving I dare say we
have more than enough ways now to
represent information input and output
so long as we all just agree on
something and thankfully oh those before
us have given us things like ASCII and
unicode not to mention MP4s Word
documents and the like but what's inside
of this proverbial black box into which
these inputs are going and the outputs
are coming well that's where we get this
term you might have heard too an
algorithm which is just step-by-step
instructions for solving some problem
incarnated in the world of computers by
software when you write software AKA
programs you are implementing one or
more algorithms one or more step sets of
instructions for solving some problem
and maybe you're using this language or
that but at the end of the day no matter
the language you use the computer is
going to represent what you type using
just zeros and ones
so what might be a representative
algorithm nowadays you might use uh your
phone quite a bit to make calls or send
texts or emails and therefore you have a
whole bunch of contacts in your address
book nowadays of course this is very
digital but whether on iOS or Android or
the like
you might have a whole bunch of names uh
first name and or last as well as
numbers and emails and the like and you
might be in the habit of like scrolling
through on your phone all of those names
to find the person you want to call it's
probably sorted alphabetically by first
name or last name a through z or some
other symbol and this is frankly quite
the same as we used to do you know back
in in my day cs50 when we just used a
physical book and this physical book
might be a whole bunch of names
alphabetically sorted from left to right
corresponding to a whole bunch of
numbers so suppose that in this Old
Harvard phone book we want to search for
John Harvard we might of course start
quite simply at the beginning here
looking at one page at a time and this
is an algorithm this is like literally
step by step looking for the solution to
this problem in that sense if John
Harvard's in the phone book is this
algorithm Page by Page correct would you
say
yes like if uh John Harvard's in the
phone book obviously I'm eventually
going to get to him so that's what we
mean by correct is it efficient is it
well designed would you say
no I mean this is going to take forever
even just to get to the JS or the H's
depending how this thing sorted all
right well let me go a little faster
I'll start like two pages at a time two
four six eight ten twelve and so forth
sounds faster is faster is it correct
okay why is it not correct yeah
exactly if I start an odd number of
pages and I'm going two at a time I met
Miss pages in between and if I therefore
conclude when I get to the back of the
book there was no John Harvard I might
have just aired this would be again one
of these bugs but if I try a little
harder I feel like there's a solution we
don't have to completely throw out this
algorithm I think we can probably go
roughly twice as fast still but what
should we do instead to fix this yeah
and back
foreign
so I think what many of us most of us if
we even use this technology anymore
these days we might go roughly to the
middle of the phone book just to kind of
get us started and now I'm looking down
I'm looking for Jay assuming first name
j Harvard and it looks like I'm in the M
section so just to be clear what should
I do next
okay and presumably it is John Harvard
would be to the left of this so here's
an opportunity to figuratively and
literally tear this particular problem
in half throw half of the problem away
it's it's actually pretty easy if you
just do it that way the hard way is this
way but I have now just uh decreased the
size of this problem really in half so
if I started with like a thousand pages
of phone numbers and names now I'm down
to 500 and already we haven't found John
Harvard but that's a big bite out of
this problem and I do think it's correct
because if J is to the left of M of
course he's definitely not going to be
over there and I think if I repeat this
again dividing and conquering if you
will here I might have gone a little too
far now I'm in like the E section so let
me tear the problem in half again throw
another 250 Pages away and again repeat
dividing and dividing and conquering
until finally presumably I end up with
just one page of a phone book on which
John Harvard's name either is or is not
but because of the algorithm you propose
step by step I know that he's not in
anything I discarded so traumatic is
that might have been
um been made out to be it's actually
just harnessing pretty good human
intuition indeed this is what
programming's all about too it's not
about learning a completely new world
but really just had a harness intuition
and ideas that you might already have
and take naturally but learning how to
express them now more succinctly more
precisely and using things called
programming languages why is an
algorithm like that if I found John
Harvard
better than ultimately just doing the
first one or even the second and maybe
doubling back to check those even pages
well let's just look at a little charts
here again we don't have to get into the
nuances of numbers but if we've got like
a chart here X Y plot on the x-axis here
I claim is the size of the problem so
measured in the numbers of pages in the
phone book so the farther you go out
here the more pages are in the phone
book and here we have time to solve on
the y-axis so the higher you go up the
more time it's going to be taking to
solve that particular problem so let's
just arbitrarily say that the first
algorithm involving like n Pages might
be represented graphically like this no
matter the slope it's a straight line
because there's presumably a one-to-one
relationship between numbers of pages
and number of seconds or number of page
turns why if the phone company adds
another page next year because some new
people move to town that's going to
require one additional page for me one
to one
if though we use the second algorithm
flawed though it was unless we double
back a little bit to fix someone being
in between that's two going to be a
straight line but it's going to be a
different slope because now there's a
two to one or a one to two relationship
because I'm going two pages at a time so
if the phone company adds another page
that's going to take me only or another
two pages that's still only just one
more step and you can see the difference
if I kind of draw this if this is the
phone book in question this number of
pages it might take this many seconds on
the yellow line to represent or to solve
uh to find someone like John Harvard but
of course on the first algorithm the red
line it's literally going to take twice
as many steps and what do the ends here
Meet n is the go-to variable for
computer scientist or programmer just
generically representing a number so if
the number of pages in the phone book is
in the number of steps the second
algorithm would have taken would be in
the worst case n over two half as many
because you're going twice as fast but
the third algorithm actually if you
recall your your logarithms looks a
little something like this there's a
fundamentally different relationship
between the size of the problem and the
amount of time required to solve it that
technically is log base 2 of n but it's
really the shape that's different and
the implication there is that if for
instance Cambridge and Alston two
different towns here in Massachusetts
merge next year and there's just one
phone book that's twice as big no big
deal for that third and final algorithm
why you just tear the problem one more
time in half taking one more bite that's
it not another thousand bites just to
get to the solution and put another way
you can walk out way way way out here to
a much bigger phone book and ultimately
that green line is barely going to have
budged so this then it's just a way of
now formalizing and thinking about
what the performance or quality of these
algorithms might be
and before we now make one more
formalization of the algorithm itself
any questions then on this notion of
efficiency or now performance of ideas
um a lot of phone books over the years
and if you or your parents have any more
still somewhere we could definitely use
them because they're hard to find
other questions but thanks
other questions here too
oh
is that a murmur yes over here
sorry say again
oh yeah hopefully and then we could uh
then we'd have a little something more
to use here so now if we want to
formalize further what it is we just did
we can go ahead and introduce this a
form of code AKA pseudo code pseudocode
is not a specific language it's not like
something we're about to start coding in
it's just a way of expressing yourself
in English or any human language
succinctly correctly toward an end of
getting your idea for an algorithm
across so for instance here might be how
we could formalize the code the pseudo
code for that same algorithm step one
was pick up the phone book as I did step
two might be open to the middle of the
phone book as you propose that we do
first step three was probably to look
down at the pages I did and step four
gets a little more interesting because I
had to quickly make a decision and ask
myself a question if person is on page
then I should probably just go ahead and
call that person but that probably
wasn't the case at least for John
Harvard and I opened the M section and
so there's this other question I should
now ask else if the person is earlier in
the book then I should tear the problem
in half as I did but go left so to speak
and then not just open to the middle of
the left half of the book but really
just go back to step three repeat myself
why because I can just repeat what I
just did but with a smaller problem
having taken this big bite but if the
person was later in the book
as might have happened with a different
person than John Harvard then I should
open to the middle of the right half of
the book again go back to line three but
again I'm not going to get stuck doing
something forever like this because I
keep shrinking the size of the problem
lastly the only possible scenario that's
left if John Harvard is not on the page
and he's not to the left and he's not to
the right what should our conclusion be
he's not there he's not listed and so we
need to quit in some other form now as
an aside it's kind of deliberate that I
buried that last question at the end
because this is how what happens all too
often in programming whether you're new
at it or professional just not
considering all possible cases Corner
cases if you will that might not happen
that often but if you don't anticipate
them in your own code pseudocode or
otherwise this is when and why programs
might crash or you might see stupid
little spinning beach balls or
hourglasses or your computer might
reboot why it's doing something sort of
unpredictable if a human maybe myself
didn't anticipate this like what does
this program do if John Harvard's not in
the phone book If I Had omitted lines 12
and 13 I don't know maybe it would
behave differently on a Mac or PC
because it's sort of undefined behavior
and these are the kinds of omissions
that frankly you're invariably going to
make bugs you're going to introduce
mistakes you're going to make early on
in me too 25 years later but you'll get
better at thinking about those Corner
cases and handling anything that can
possibly go wrong and as a result your
code will be all the better for it now
the problem ultimately with learning how
to program especially if you've never
had experience or even if you do but you
learned a but one language only is that
they all look a little cryptic at first
glance but they do share certain
commonalities and in fact we'll use this
pseudo code to define those first
highlighted in yellow here or what
henceforth we're going to start calling
functions lots of different programming
languages exist but most of them have
what we might call functions which are
actions or verbs that solve some smaller
problem that is to say you might use a
whole bunch of functions to solve a
bigger problem because each functions
tend to do each function tends to do
something very specific or precise these
then in English might be translated in
code actual computer code to these
things called functions highlighted in
yellow now are what we might call
conditionals conditionals are things
that you do conditionally based on the
answer to some question you can think of
them kind of like Forks in the road you
go left or go right or some other
direction in based on the answer to some
question well what are those questions
highlighted now in yellow or what we
would call Boolean Expressions named
after a mathematician last name bull
that simply have yes no answers or if
you prefer true or false answers or Heck
if you prefer one or zero answers we
just need to distinguish one scenario
from another the last thing manifest in
this pseudo code is what I might
highlight now and call Loops some kind
of cycle some kind of directive that
tells us to do something again and again
so that I don't need a thousand line
program to search a thousand page phone
book I can get away with a 13 line
program but sort of repeat myself
inherently in order to solve some
problem until I get to that last step so
this then is what we might call
pseudocode and indeed there are other
characteristics of programs that we'll
touch on before long things like
arguments and return values variables
and more
but unfortunately in most languages
including some we will very deliberately
use in this class and that everyone in
the rural World these days still uses is
programs tend to look like this this for
instance is a distillation of that very
first program I wrote in 1996 in cs50
itself just to print something on the
screen and in fact this version here
just tries to print quote unquote hello
world which is dare say the most
canonical first thing that most any
programmer ever gets a computer to say
just because
but look at this mess I mean there's a
hash symbol these angled brackets
parentheses words like end curly braces
quotes parentheses semicolons and
backslashes I mean there's more overhead
and more syntax and clutter than there
is an actual idea now that's not to say
that you won't be able to understand
this before long because honestly
there's not that many patterns indeed
programming languages have typically a
much smaller vocabulary than any actual
human language but at first it might
indeed look quite cryptic but you can
perhaps infer I have no idea what these
other ones do yet but hello world is
presumably quote unquote what will be
printed on the screen but what we'll do
today after a short break and set the
stage for next week is introduce these
exact same ideas in just a bit using
scratch something that you yourselves
might have used when you're quite
younger but without the same vocabulary
apply to those ideas and the upside of
what we'll soon do using scratch this
graphical programming language from her
friends down the road at MIT it'll let
us to day start to drag and drop things
that look like puzzle pieces that
interlock together from it's logical
sense to do so but without the
distraction of hashes parentheses curly
braces angle brackets semicolons and
things that are quite beside the point
but for now let's go ahead and take a 10
minute break here and when we resume we
will start programming so this on the
screen is a language called C something
that we'll dive into next week and
thankfully this now on the screen is
another language called python that will
also take a look at in a few weeks
before long along with other languages
along the way today though and for this
first week week zero so to speak we use
scratch because again it'll allow us to
explore some of those programming
fundamentals that will be in C and in
Python and in JavaScript and other
languages too but in a way where we
don't have to worry about the
distractions of syntax so the world of
scratch looks like this it's a web-based
or downloadable programming environment
that has this layout here by default on
the left here we'll soon see is a
palette of puzzle pieces programming
blocks that represent all of those ideas
we just discussed and by dragging and
dropping these puzzle pieces or blocks
over this to Big area and connecting
them together if it makes logical sense
to do so we'll start programming in this
environment the environment allows you
to have multiple Sprites so to speak
multiple characters things like a cat or
anything else and those Sprites exist in
this rectangular World up here that you
can full screen to make bigger and this
here by default is scratch who can move
up down left right into many more things
too and within it scratches world you
can think of it as perhaps a familiar a
coordinate system with x's and y's which
is helpful only when it comes time to
like position things on the screen right
now scratch is at the default zero comma
zero where x equals zero and Y equals
zero if you were to move the cat way up
to the top X would stay zero y would be
positive 180. if you move the cat all
the way to the bottom X would stay zero
but y would now be negative 180 and if
you went left X would become negative
240 but y would stay zero or to the
right X would be 240 and Y would stay
zero so those numbers generally don't so
much matter because you can just move
relatively in this world up down left
right but when it comes time to like
precisely position some of these Sprites
or other imagery it'll be helpful just
to have that mental model of up down
left and right well let's go ahead and
make perhaps the simplest of programs
here I'm going to switch over to the
same programming environment now for a
tour of the left hand side so by default
selected here are the category in blue
motion which has a whole bunch of puzzle
pieces or blocks that relate to motion
and whereas scratch as a graphical
language categorizes things by the type
of things that these pieces do we'll see
that throughout this whole palette we'll
have functions and variables and
conditionals and Boolean expressions and
more each in a different color and shape
so for instance moving 10 steps or
turning one way or or the other would be
functions categorized here as things
like motion under looks in purple you
might have speech bubbles that you can
create by dragging and dropping these
that might say hello or whatever for
some number of seconds or you could
switch costumes change the cat to look
like a dog or a bird or anything else in
between sounds too you can play sounds
like meow or anything you might import
or record yourself and then there's
these things scratch calls events and
the most important of these is the first
when green flag clicked because if we
look over to the right of scratch's
world here this rectangular region has
this green flag and red stop sign up
above one of which is for play one of
which is for stop and so that's going to
allow us to start and stop our actual
programs when that green flag is
initially clicked but you can listen for
other types of events when the space bar
is pressed or something else when this
Sprite is clicked or something else and
here you already see like a programmer's
incarnation of things you and I take for
granted like every day now on our phones
anytime you tap an icon or drag your
finger or hit a button on the side these
are what a programmer would call events
things that happen and are often
triggered by us humans and things that a
program be it in scratch or python or C
or anything else can listen for and
respond to indeed that's why when you
tap the phone icon on your phone the
phone application starts up because
someone wrote software that's listening
for a finger press on that particular
icon and so scratch has these same
things too under control in Orange you
can see that we can wait for one second
or repeat something some number of times
10 by default but we can change anything
in these white circles to anything else
there's another puzzle piece here
forever which implies some kind of loop
where we can do something again and
again and even though it seems a little
tight there's not much room to fit
something there scratch is going to have
these things grow and Shrink however we
want to fill similarly shaped pieces and
here's those conditionals if something
is true or false then do this this next
thing and that's how we can put in this
little trapezoid-like shape some form of
Boolean expression a question with a yes
no true false or one zero answer and
decide whether to do something or not
you can mess combine these things too if
something is true do this else do this
other thing and you can even tuck one
inside of the other if you want to ask
three or four or more questions sensing
two is going to be a thing you can ask
questions AKA Boolean expressions like
is the Sprite touching the mouse pointer
the arrow on the screen so that you can
start to interact with these programs
what is the distance between a Sprite
and a mouse pointer you can do simple
calculations just to figure out maybe if
the the enemy is getting close to the
cat under operator some lower level
stuff like math but also the ability to
pick random numbers which for a game is
great because then you can kind of vary
the difficulty or what's happening in a
game without the same game playing the
same way every time and you can combine
ideas something and something must be
true in order to make that kind of
decisions before or we can even join two
words together says apple and banana
default but you can type in or drag and
drop whatever you want there to combine
multiple words into full larger
sentences and then lastly down here
there's an orange things called
variables in math we've obviously got X
and Y and whatnot in programming we'll
have the same ability to sort of store
in these named symbols X or Y of values
that we care about numbers or letters or
words or colors or anything ultimately
but in programming you'll see that it's
much more conventional not to just use
Simple letters like X and Y and Z but to
actually give variables full words or
were singular or plural words to
describe what they are
and then lastly if this isn't enough
colors uh blocks for you you can create
your own blocks and indeed this is going
to be a programming principle will apply
today and with the first problem set
whereby once you start to assemble these
puzzle pieces and you realize oh would
it be nice if those several pieces could
have just been replaced by one had MIT
fought to give me that one puzzle piece
you yourself can make your own blocks by
connecting these all together giving
them a name and boom a new puzzle piece
will exist so let's do the simplest most
canonical programs here starting up with
control and I'm going to click and drag
and drop this thing here when green flag
clicked and then I'm going to grab one
more for instance under looks and under
looks I'm going to go ahead and just say
something like initially
not just hello but the more canonical
hello comma world now you might guess
that in this programming environment I
can go over here now and click the green
flag and voila hello comma world so
that's my first program and obviously
much more user friendly than typing out
the much more cryptic text that we saw
on the screen that you too will type out
next week but for now we'll just focus
on these ideas and in this case a
function so what it is that just that
just happened this purple block here is
say that's the function and it seems to
take some form of input in the white
oval specifically hello comma World well
this actually fits the Paradigm that we
looked at earlier of just inputs and
outputs so if I may if you consider what
this puzzle piece is doing it actually
fits this model the input in this case
is going to be hello comma World in
white the algorithm is going to be
implemented as a function by MIT called
say and the output of that is going to
be some kind of side effect like the cat
and the speech bubble are saying hello
world so already even that simple drag
and drop mimics exactly this relatively
simple mental model so let's take things
further let's go ahead now and make the
program a little more interactive so
that it says something like hello David
or hello Carter or hello to you
specifically and for this I'm going to
go under sensing and you might have to
poke around to find these things the
first time around but I've done this a
few times so I kind of know where things
are and what color there's this function
here ask what's your name but that's in
white so we can change the question to
anything we want and it's going to wait
for the human to type in their answer
and this function called ask is a little
different from the say block which just
had this side effect of printing a
speech bubble to the screen the ask
function is even more powerful in that
after it asks the human to type
something in this function is going to
hand you back what they typed in in the
form of what's called a return value
which is stored ultimately and by
default this thing called answer this
little blue oval here called answer is
again one of these variables that in
math would be called just X or Y but in
programming we were saying what it does
so I'm going to go ahead and do this let
me go ahead and drag and drop this block
and I want to ask the question before
saying anything but you'll notice that
scratch is smart and it's going to
realize I want to insert something in
between and it's just going to move
things up and down I'm going to let go
and ask the default question what's your
name and now if I want to go ahead and
say hello David or Carter let's just do
hello comma because I obviously don't
know when I'm writing the program who's
going to use it so let me now grab
another looks block up here say
something again and now let me go back
to sensing and now grab the return value
represented by this other puzzle piece
and let me just drag and drop it here
and notice it's the same shape even if
it's not quite the same size things will
grow or Shrink as needed all right so
let's now zoom out let me go and stop
the old versions because I don't want to
say hello world anymore let me hit the
green flag and what's my name all right
David enter
huh all right maybe I just wasn't paying
close enough attention let me try it
again green flag d-a-v-i-d enter
this seems like a bug
what's the bugger mistake might you
think
uh yeah
yeah we kind of want to combine them in
the same text box and it's you know it's
technically a bug because this just
looks kind of stupid it's just saying
David after I asked for my name I'd like
it to say maybe hello then David but
it's just blowing past the hello and
printing David but let's put our finger
on why this is happening you're right
for the solution but what's the actual
fundamental problem in back
perfect I mean computers are really darn
fast these days it is saying hello all
of us are just too slow in this room to
even see it because it's then saying
David on the screen so fast as well so
there's a couple of solutions here and
yours is spot on but just to poke around
you'll see the first example of how many
ways in programming be it scratch or C
or python or anything else that they're
going to be to solve problems and will
teach you over the course of this weeks
Sometimes some ways are better
relatively than others but rarely is
there a Best Way necessarily because
again reasonable people will disagree
and what we'll try to teach you over the
coming weeks is how to kind of think
through those nuances and it's not going
to be obvious at first glance but the
more programs you write the more
feedback you get the more bugs that you
introduce the more you'll get your
footing with exactly this kind of
problem solving so let me try this in a
couple of ways up here would be one
solution to the problem MIT anticipated
this kind of issue especially with
first-time programmers and I could just
use puzzle piece that says say the
following for two seconds or one second
or whatever then do the same with the
next word and it might be kind of a bit
of a pause hello one second two seconds
David one second two seconds but at
least it would look a little more
grammatically correct but I can do it a
little more elegantly as you proposed
let me go ahead and throw away one of
these blocks and you can just drag and
let go and it'll delete itself let me go
down to operators
because this join block here is the
right shape and so even if you're not
sure what goes where just focus on the
shapes first let me drag this over here
and it grew to fill that let me go ahead
and say hello comma space and now it
could just say by default hello banana
but let me go back to let me go back to
sensing drag answer and that's going to
drag and drop there and so now notice
we're sort of stacking or nesting one
block on another so that the output of
one becomes the input to another but
that's okay here let me go ahead and
zoom out hit stop and hit play all right
what's your name d-a-b-i-d enter and
voila now it's presumably as we first
intended so thank you
foreign
thank you no no minus two this time
let's consider that even with these uh
this additional example it still fits
the same mental model but in a little
more interesting way here's that new
function ask something and wait and
notice that in this case too there's an
input Otherwise Known henceforth as an
argument or a parameter programming
speak for just an input in the context
of a function and if we use our drawing
as before to represent this thing here
we'll see that the input now is going to
be quote unquote what's your name the
algorithm is going to be implemented by
way of this new puzzle piece the
function called ask and the output of
that thing this time is not going to be
the cat saying anything yet but rather
it's going to be the actual answer so
instead of the visual side effect of the
speech bubble appearing now nothing
visible is happening yet thanks to this
function it's sort of handing me back
like a scrap of paper with whatever I
typed in written on it so I can reuse
David one or more times even like I did
now what did I then do with that value
well consider that with the subsequent
function
with the subsequent function we had this
say block 2 combined with a join so we
have this variable called answer we're
joining it with that first argument
hello so already we see that some
functions like join can take not one but
two arguments or inputs and that's fine
the output of join is presumably going
to be hello David or hello Carter or
whatever the human typed in and that
output notice is essentially becoming
the input to another function say just
because we've kind of stacked things or
nested them on top of one another but
graphic or but um but methodically it's
really the same idea the input now are
two things hello comma and the return
value from the previous ask function the
function now is going to be joined the
output is going to be hello David but
that hello David output is now going to
become the input to another function
namely that first block called say and
that's then going to have the side
effect of printing out hello David on
the screen so again it's sort of
sophisticated as ours is yours as others
programs are going to get they really do
fit this very simple mental model of
inputs and outputs and you just have to
learn to recognize the vocabulary and to
know what kinds of puzzle pieces or
concepts ultimately to apply but you can
ultimately really kind of spice these
things up let me go back to my program
here that just is using the speech
bubble at the moment scratch as an aside
has some pretty fancy interactive
features too I click the extensions
button in the bottom left corner and let
me go ahead and choose the text to
speech extension this is using a cloud
service so if you have an internet
connection it can actually talk to the
cloud or a third-party service and this
one's going to give me a few new green
puzzle pieces namely the ability to
speak something from my speakers instead
of just saying it textually so let me go
ahead and drag this and now notice I
don't have to interlock them if I'm just
kind of playing around and I want to
move some things around I just want to
use this as like a canvas temporarily
let me go ahead and steal the join from
here put it there let me throw away the
save block by just moving it left and
letting go and now let me show join this
in so I've now changed my program to be
a little more interesting so now let me
stop the old version let me start the
new
what's your name type in David and voila
hello banana
okay minus two for real all right so
what I accidentally threw away there
uh intentionally for instructional
purposes was the actual answer that came
back from the ask block that's
embarrassing so now if I play this again
let's click the green icon what's your
name David and now hello David there we
go hello David all right thank you
okay so we have these functions then in
place but what more can we do well what
about those conditionals and and loops
and other constructs how can we bring
these programs to life so it's not just
clicking a button and voila something's
happening let's go ahead and make this
now even more interactive let me go
ahead and throw away most of these
pieces and let me just spice things up
with some more audio under sound I'm
going to go to play sound meow until
done here we go green flag
okay it's a little loud but it did
exactly do what it said let's hear it
again
[Music]
okay it's kind of an underwhelming
program eventually since you'd like to
think that the cat would just meow on
its own but I have to keep hitting the
button well this seems like an
opportunity for uh doing something again
and again so all right well if I wanted
to meow meow meow let me just grab a few
of these or you can even right click or
control click and you can copy paste
even in code here let me play this now
all right so now like it's not really
emoting happiness in quite the same way
it might be hungry or upset so you know
let's slow it down let me go to control
wait one second in between which might
be a little
uh let's worry some here we go play
[Music]
Okay so
if my goal was to make the cat meow
three times I dare say this code or
algorithm is correct but let's now
critique its design is this
well-designed and if not why not
what are your thoughts here uh yeah
sure yeah
yeah so yeah agreed I could use forever
a repeat but let me push a little harder
but why like this works I'm kind of done
with the assignments what do I what's
bad about it
yeah there's too much repetition right
if I wanted to change the sound that the
cat is making to like a different
variant of meow or have it bark instead
like a dog I could change it from the
drop down here apparently but then I'd
have to change it here and then I'd have
to change it here and God if this were
even longer that just gets tedious
quickly and you're probably increasing
the probability that you're going to
screw up and you're going to miss one of
the drop downs or something stupid and
introduce a bug or if you wanted to
change the number of seconds you're
waiting you've got to change it into
maybe even more places again you're just
creating risk for yourself and potential
bugs in the program so I do like the
repeat or the forever idea so that I
don't repeat myself and indeed what I
alluded to being possible copy pasting
earlier doesn't mean it's a good thing
and in code generally speaking when you
start to copy and paste puzzle pieces or
text next week you're probably not doing
something quite well so let me go ahead
and throw away most of these to get rid
of the duplication keeping just two of
the blocks that I care about let me grab
the repeat block for now let me move
this inside of the repeat heat Block
it's going to grow to fit it let me
reconnect all this and change the 10
just to a 3 and now play
[Music]
so better it's the same thing it's still
correct but now I've set the stage to
let the cat meow for instance four times
by changing one thing 40 times by
changing one thing or I could just use
the forever block and just walk away and
it will meow forever instead if that's
your goal that would be better a better
design but still correct but you know
what now that I have a program that's
designed to have a cat meow wow like why
I mean MIT invented scratch scratch is a
cat why is there no puzzle piece called
meow this feels like a missed
opportunity now to be fair they gave us
all the building blocks with which we
could Implement that idea but a
principle of programming and really
computer science is to leverage what
we're going to now start calling
abstraction we have a step-by-step
instructions here the repeat the play
and the weight that collectively
implements this idea that we humans
would call meowing wouldn't it be nice
to abstract away those several puzzle
pieces into just one that literally just
says what it does meow well here's where
we can make our own blocks let me go
over here to scratch under the pink
block category here
and let me click make a block and here I
see a slightly different interface where
I can choose a name for it I'm going to
call it meow and I'm going to keep it
simple that's it no inputs to meow yet
I'm just going to click ok now just
going to clean this up a bit here let me
drag and drop play sound and wait over
here and you know what I'm just going to
drag this way down here way down here
because now that I'm done implementing
meow I'm going to literally abstract it
away sort of out of sight out of mind
because now notice at top left there is
a new pink puzzle piece called meow and
so at this point I'd argue it doesn't
really matter how meow is implemented
frankly I don't know how ask or say was
implemented by MIT they abstracted those
things away for us now I have a brand
new puzzle piece that just says what it
is and this is now still correct but
arguably better design why because it's
just more readable to me to you it's
more maintainable when you look at your
code a year from now for the first time
because you're sort of fondly looking
back at the very first program you wrote
it says what it does the function itself
has semantics which conveys what's going
on if you really care about how meow is
implemented you could scroll down and
start to Tinker with the underlying
implementation details but otherwise you
don't need to care anymore now I feel
like there's a even additional
opportunity here for abstraction and to
sort of factor out some of this
functionality it's kind of lame that I
have this repeat block that lets me call
the meow function so to speak use the
meow function three times wouldn't it be
nice if I could just call the meow
function AKA use the meow function and
pass it in input that tells the puzzle
piece how many times I want it to meow
well let me go ahead and zoom out and
scroll down let me right click or
control click on the pink piece here and
choose edit or I could just start from
scratch no pun intended with a new one
and now here rather than just give this
thing a name now let me go ahead and add
an input here and I'm going to go ahead
and type in for instance n for number of
times to meow and just to make this even
more user friendly and self-descriptive
I'm going to add a label which has no
functional impact it's just an aesthetic
and I'm just going to say times just to
make it read more like English in this
case that tells me what the puzzle piece
does and now I'm going to click OK and
now I need to refine this a little bit
let me go ahead and grab under control a
repeat block
let me move the play sound and weight
into the repeat block I don't want 10
and I also don't want 3 here what I want
now is This n That is my actual variable
that scratch is creating for me that
represents whatever input the human
programmer provides notice it snaps
right in place let me connect this and
now voila I have an even fancier version
of meow that is parameterized it takes
input that affects Its Behavior
accordingly now I'm going to scroll back
up because out of sight out of mind I
just care that meow exists now I can
tighten up my code so to speak use even
fewer lines to do the same thing by
throwing away the repeat block
reconnecting this new puzzle piece here
that takes an input like three and voila
now we're really programming right we've
not made any forward progress
functionally the thing just meows three
times but it's a better design and as
you program more and more these are the
kinds of instincts still start to
acquire so that one you can start to
take a big assignment a big problem set
something for homework even that feels
is kind of overwhelming at first like oh
my God where do I even begin but if you
start to identify what are the sub
problems of a bigger problem then you
can start making progress and I do this
to this day where if I have to tackle
some programming related project I'm so
easy to like drag my feet or oh it's
going to take forever to start until I
just start writing down like a to-do
list and I start to modularize the
program and say all right well what do I
want this thing to do meowing what's
that mean I gotta have it say something
on the screen all right I need to have
it say something on the screen some
number of times like literally a mental
or written checklist or pseudo code if
you will in English on a piece of paper
or text file and then you can decide
okay the first thing I need to do for
homework to solve this real world
problem I just need a meow function I
need to use a bunch of other code too
but I need to create a meow function and
boom now you have a piece of the problem
solved not unlike we did with the phone
book there but in this case we'll have
presumably other problems to solve all
right so what more can we do let's add a
few more pieces just to the puzzle here
let's actually interact with the cat now
let me go ahead and now when the green
flag is clicked let me go ahead and ask
a question using an event here let me go
ahead and say if
let's see if the cursor I want to do
something like uh implement the notion
of petting the cat so if the cursor is
petting touching the cat like here
something like this it'd be cute if like
the cat meows like you're petting a cat
so I'm going to ask the question when
the green flag is clicked if let's see I
think I need sensing so if touching
Mouse pointer this is way too big but
again the shape is fine so there it goes
screw to fill and then if it's touching
the mouse pointer that is if the cat to
whom this script or this program anytime
I attach puzzle pieces MIT calls them a
script or like a program if you will let
me go ahead then and choose a sound and
say play sound meow until done alright
so here it is to be clear when the green
flag is clicked ask the question if the
cat is touching the mouse pointer then
play sound meow here we go play
huh all right let's try again
play
huh
I'm worried it's not
scratch's fault Feels Like Mine what's
the bug here
why doesn't this work yeah and back
yeah who just turned
yeah the problem is the moment I click
that green flag scratch asks the
question is the cat touching the mouse
pointer and obviously it's not because
the cursor was like up there a moment
ago and it's not down there it's fine if
I move the cursor down there but too
late the program already asked the
question the answer was no or false or
zero however you want to think about it
so no sound was played so what might be
the solution here be I could move my my
cursor quickly but that feels like never
going to work out right other Solutions
here
yeah and way back
the forever Loop so I could indeed use
this forever Loop because if I want my
program to just constantly listen to me
well let's literally do something
forever or at least forever as long as
the program is running until I
explicitly hit stop so let me grab that
let me go to control let me grab the
forever block let me move the if inside
of this forever block reconnect this go
back up here click the green flag and
now nothing's happened yet but let me
try moving my cursor now
ah so now
that's kind of cute so now the cat is
actually responding and it's going to
keep doing this again and again and so
now we have this idea of taking these
different ideas these different puzzle
pieces assembling them into something
more complicated and I could definitely
put a a name to this I could create a
custom block but for now let's just
consider what kind of more interactivity
we can do let me go ahead and do this by
again grabbing a when green flag clicked
let me go ahead and click the video
sensing
and I'm going to rotate the laptop
because otherwise we're going to get a
little Inception thing here where the
camera is picking up the camera is up
there so I'm gonna go
reveal to you what's inside the lectern
here
well we rotate this
and now that we have a non-video
backdrop I'm going to say this instead
of the green flag clicked actually I'm
going to say when the video motion is
greater than some arbitrary measurement
of motion I'm going to go ahead and play
sound meow until done
and then I'm going to get out of the way
so here's the cat and let's put it we'll
put them on top
on top of there just okay
all right and here we go
[Music]
so my hand is moving faster than 50
something or other whatever the unit of
measure is
and we thank you so now we have even
more interactive version
but I think if I sort of
slowly
right I'm not it's completely creepy but
I'm not like exceeding
the threshold
until finally my hand moves as fast as
that and so here actually is an
opportunity to show you something a
former student did let me go ahead here
and okay I gotta stop this let me go
ahead and zoom out of this in just a
moment uh if someone would be
if someone would be comfortable coming
up of not only Mass but also on camera
on the internet thought we'd play one of
your former classmates projects here up
on stage would anyone like to volunteer
here and be up on stage who's that yeah
come on down what's your name
Sahar all right come on down let me get
it set up for you here
[Applause]
all right let me go ahead and full
screen this here so this is a
whack-a-mole by one of your firmer
predecessors it's going to use the
camera focusing on your head which we'll
have to position inside of this
rectangle and have you ever played the
like whack-a-mole game at an arcade okay
so for those who haven't like these
little moles pop up and with a very
fuzzy Hammer you sort of hit down you
though if you don't mind you're going to
use your head to do this virtually
so let's line up your head with this red
rectangle if you could
we'll do beginner
all right here we go Sahar
give it a moment
okay come a little closer
and now hit the moles with your head
[Music]
there we go one point
one point
nice
15 seconds to go there we go oh yep one
point
that night
six seconds
there we go quick
all right a round of applause thank you
so beyond having a little bit of fun
here the goal was to demonstrate that by
using some fairly simple primitive some
basic building blocks but assembling
them in a fun way with some music maybe
some new costumes or artwork you can
really bring programs to life but at the
end of the day the only puzzle piece is
really involved were ones like the ones
I just dragged and dropped and a few
more because there were clearly lots of
moles so the student probably created a
few different Sprites not a single cap
but at least four different moles they
had like some kind of graphic on the
screen that showed the hardware to
position her head there was some kind of
timer maybe a variable that every second
was counting down so you can imagine
taking what looks like a pretty
impressive project at first glance and
perhaps overwhelming to solve yourself
but just think about what are the basic
building blocks and pluck off one piece
of the puzzle so to speak at a time and
so indeed if we rewind a little bit let
me go ahead here and introduce a program
that I myself made back in graduate
school when scratch was first being
developed by MIT let me go ahead and
open here give me just one second
something that I called back in the day
Oscar time that looks a little something
like this if I full screen it and hit
play
so you'll notice a piece of trash is
falling I can click on it and drag and
as I get close and close to the trash
can notice
it wants to go in it seems and if I let
go
one point
here comes another
I'll do the same two points
there's a sneaker falling from the sky
so another Sprite of some sort
I can also get just a little a little
lazy and just let them fall into the
trash themselves if I want to
so you can see it doesn't have to do
with my mouse cursor it has to do
apparently with the distance here let's
listen a little further I think there's
some additional trash is about to make
its appearance presumably there's some
kind of like variable that's keeping
track of this score
okay let's see what the last the last
chorus here is
[Music]
okay and thus it continues and uh this
song actually goes on and on and on and
I do not have fond memories of
implementing this and hearing this song
for like 10 straight hours but it's a
good example to just consider how was
this program composed how did I go about
implementing it the first time around
and let me go ahead and open up some
programs now that I wrote in advance
just so that we could see how these
things are assembled honestly the first
thing I probably did
was probably to do something a little
like this here is just a version of the
program where I set out to solve just
one problem first of planting a lamp
post in the program right I kind of had
a vision of what I wanted you know it
evolved over time certainly but I knew I
went to trash to fall I wanted a cute
little Oscar the Grouch to pop out of
the trash can and some other stuff but
wow that's a lot to just tackle all at
once I'm going to start easy download a
picture of a lamp post and then drag and
drop it into the stage as a costume and
boom that's version one it doesn't
functionally do anything I mean
literally that's the code that I wrote
to do this all I did was use like the
backdrops feature and drag and drop and
move things around but it got me to
version one of my program then what
might version two be well I considered
what piece of functionality frankly
might be the easiest to pluck off next
and the trash can that seems like a
pretty core piece of functionality it
just needs to sit there most of the time
so the next thing I probably did was to
open up for instance the trash can
version here that looks a little
something now like this so this time
I'll show you what's inside here there
is some code but not much notice at
bottom right I change the default cat to
a picture of a trash can instead but
it's the same principle that I can
control and then over here I added this
code when the green flag is clicked
switch the costume to something I
arbitrarily called Oscar one so I found
a couple of different pictures of a
trash can one that looks closed one that
looks partly open and eventually one
that has Oscar coming out and I just
gave them different names so I said
switch to Oscar one which is the closed
one by default then forever do the
following if touching the mouse pointer
then switch the costume to Oscar 2 I'll
switch to Oscar one that is to say I
just wanted to implement this idea of
like the can opening and closing even if
it's not exactly what I wanted
ultimately I just wanted to make some
forward progress so here when I run this
program
by clicking play notice what happens
nothing yet but if I get closer to the
trash can
it indeed pops open because it's forever
listening for whether the Sprite the
trash can in this case is touching the
mouse pointer and that's it that was
version two if you will and if I went in
now and added the lamp post and composed
the program together now we're starting
to make progress right now it would look
a little something more like the program
I intended ultimately to create what
piece did I probably bite off after that
well I think what I did is I probably
decided let me Implement one of the
pieces of trash not the shoe in the
newspaper all at once let's just get one
piece of trash working correctly first
and so let me go ahead and open this one
and again all these examples will be
available on the course's website so you
can see all of these examples too it's
not terribly long I just implemented in
advance so we could flip through kind of
quickly here's what I did here on the
right hand side I turned my Sprite into
a piece of trash this time instead of a
cat instead of a trash can and I also
created with Carter's help a second
Sprite this one a floor it's literally
just a black line because I just want it
initially to have some notion of a floor
so I could detect if the trash is
touching the floor now without seeing
the code yet just hearing that
description why might I have wanted the
second Sprite and this black line for a
floor
with the trash intending to fall from
the sky what might I have been thinking
like what problem might I be trying to
solve yeah
yeah you don't want the first Sprites
you start at the top go through and then
boom like you completely lose it like
that would not be a very uh useful thing
or it would seem to maybe eat up more
and more of the computer's memory if the
trash is just endlessly falling and I
can't grab it uh might be a little
traumatic if you try to get it and you
can't pull it back out and you can't fix
the program and so I just wanted the
thing to stop so how might I have
implemented this let's look at the code
at left here I have
a bit of Randomness like I proposed
earlier exists there's this blue
function called go to x comma y that
lets me move a spray to any position up
down left right I picked a random X
location either here or over here
negative 240 to positive four 240 and
then a y value of 180 which is the top
and this just makes the game more
interesting it's kind of lame pretty
quickly if the trash always falls from
the same spot here's just a little bit
of Randomness like most any game would
have that spices things up and so now if
I click the green flag you'll see that
it just Falls nothing interesting is
going to happen but it does stop when it
touches the black line because notice
what we did here I'm forever asking the
question if the distance of the Sprite
the trash is to the floor is greater
than zero that's fine change the Y
location to by negative three so move it
down three pixels down three pixels
until the distance to the floor is not
greater than zero it is zero or even
negative at which point it should to
stop moving all together there's other
ways we could have implemented this but
this felt like a nice clean way that
logically just made it make sense and
okay now I got some trash falling I got
a trash can that opens and closes I have
a lamp post now I'm you know a good
three steps into the program we're
making progress if we consider one or
two final pieces something like the
dragging of the trash let me go ahead
and open up this version to
dragging the trash requires a different
type of question let me zoom in here
here's the piece of trash I only need
one Sprite no floor here because I just
want the human to move it up down left
right and the human's not going to
physically be able to move it outside of
the world and if we zoom in on this code
the way we've solved this is as follows
we're using that and conjunction that we
glimpsed earlier because when the green
flag is clicked we're forever asking
this question or really these questions
plural if the mouse is down and the cat
or sorry the trash is touching the mouse
pointer that's equivalent logically to
clicking on the trash go ahead and move
the trash to the mouse pointer so again
it takes this very familiar idea that
you and I take for granted every day on
Max and PCs of clicking and dragging and
dropping how is that implemented well
Maco uh Mac OS or windows are probably
asking a question over every icon is the
mouse down and is the icon touching the
mouse if so go to the location of the
mouse forever while that Mouse button is
clicked down so how does this work in
reality now let me go ahead and click on
the play nothing happens at first but if
I click on it I can move it up down left
right it doesn't move thereafter so I
now need to kind of combine this idea of
dragging with falling but I bet I could
just start to use just one single
program right now I'm using separate
ones to show different ideas but now
that's another bite out of the problem
and if we do one last one something like
the score keeping is interesting because
recall that every time we dragged a
piece of trash into the can Oscar popped
out and told us the current score so let
me go ahead and find this one Oscar
variables
and let me zoom in on this one and this
one is longer because we combined all of
these elements so this is the kind of
thing that if you looked at at first
glance like I have no idea how I would
have implemented this from nothing from
scratch literally but again if you
Vision take your vision and componentize
it into these smaller bite-sized
problems you could take these baby steps
so to speak and then solve everything
collectively so what's new here is this
bottom one
forever do the following if the trash is
touching Oscar the other Sprite that
we've now added to the program change
the score by one this is an orange and
indeed if we poke around we'll see that
orange is a variable like an X or a y
but with a better name changing it means
to add one or if it's negative subtract
one and then go ahead and have the trash
go to pick random what what is this all
about well let me let me show you what
it's doing and then we can infer
backwards let me go ahead and hit play
all right it's falling I'm clicking and
dragging it I'm moving it over and I'm
Letting Go
all right let me do it once more letting
go
let me stop why do I have this function
at the end called go to X and Y
randomly like what problem is this
solving here yeah and way back
yeah exactly even though the human
perceives this as like a lot of trash
falling from the sky it's actually the
same piece of trash just kind of being
magically moved back to the top as
though it's a new one and there too you
have this idea of reusable code if you
were constantly copying and pasting your
pieces of trash and creating 20 pieces
of trash 30 pieces of trash just because
you want the game to have that many
levels probably doing something wrong
reuse the code that you wrote reuse the
Sprites that you wrote and that would
give you not just correctness but also a
better design well let's take a look at
one final set of building blocks that we
can compose ultimately into something
particularly interactive as follows let
me go ahead and zoom out here and let me
propose that we Implement something like
um like some kind of maze based game and
let me go ahead here so I want to
implement some maze based game that
looks at first glance like this let me
hit play it's not a very fun game yet
but here's a little Harvard Shield a
couple of black lines this time vertical
instead of horizontal but notice you
can't quite see my hand here but I'm
using my arrow keys to go down to go up
to go left to go right but if I keep
going right right right right right
right right right it's not going
anywhere and left left left left left
left left left left left left it
eventually stops so before we look at
the code how might this be working
what kinds of scripts collections of
puzzle pieces might collectively help us
implement this what do you think
perfect yeah there's probably some
question being asked if touching the
black line and it happens to be a couple
of Sprites Each of which is just
literally a vertical black line we're
probably asking a question like are you
touching it or is the distance to it
zero or close to zero and if so we just
ignore the up down left or rather we
ignore the left or the right arrow at
that point so that works but otherwise
if we're not touching a wall what are we
probably doing instead forever here how
is the movement working presumably yeah
and back
oh you might are you scratching
okay sure let's go on
sorry say a little louder
exactly it's continually forever looking
or listening for the arrow keys up down
left right and if the up arrow is
pressed we're probably changing the Y by
a positive value uh if the down arrow is
pressed we're High going down by Y and
left and right accordingly so let's
actually take a quick look if I zoom out
here and take a look at the code that
implements this there's a lot going on
at first glance but let's see first of
all let me drag some stuff out of the
way because it's kind of overwhelming at
first glance especially if you for
instance were poking around online as
for problem set zero just to get
inspiration most projects out there are
going to look overwhelming at first
glance until you start to wrap your mind
around what's going on but in this case
we've implemented some abstractions from
the get-go to sort of explain to
ourselves and to anyone else looking at
the code what's going on this is that
program with the two black lines and the
Harvard Shield going up down left and
right it initially puts the shield in
the middle zero comma zero it then
forever listens for keyboard as I think
you were describing and it feels for the
walls as I think you were just driving
now how is that implemented don't know
yet these are custom blocks we created
as abstractions to kind of hide those
implementation details because honestly
that's all I need to know right now but
as aspiring programmers if we're curious
now let's scroll down to the actual
implementation of listening for keyboard
this is the one on the left and it is a
little long but it's a lot of similar
structure we're doing the following if
the up arrow is pressed then change by y
by one go up if the down arrow is
pressed then change by negative one go
down right arrow left arrow and that's
it so it just assembles all of those
ideas combines it into one new block
just because it's kind of overwhelming
let's just implement it once and tuck it
away and if we scroll now over to the
feel for walls function this now is
asking the question as hypothesized if
I'm touching the left wall change my x
value by one sort of move away from it a
little bit if I'm touching the right
wall then move X by negative 1 to move a
little bit away from it so it kind of
bounces off the wall just in case it
slightly went over we keep the crest
within those two walls all right so then
a couple of more pieces here to
introduce what if we want to actually
add some kind of adversary or opponent
to this game well let me go ahead to um
maybe this one here where the adversary
in this game might for instance be
designed to be bouncing to stand in your
way if this is like a maze and you're
trying to get the hardwood shield from
the bottom to the top or vice versa uh
oh Yale is in the way and it seems to be
automatically bouncing back and forth
here well let me ask someone else
hypothesize how is this working
this is an idea you have this is an idea
you see let's reverse engineer
in your head how it works
how might this be working yeah and back
yeah so if the Yale symbol is touching
the left wall or the right wall we
somehow have it bounce and indeed we'll
see there's a puzzle piece that can do
exactly that technically off the edge as
we'll see but there's another way we can
do this and let's look at the code the
way we ourselves can Implement exactly
that idea bounce is just with a little
bit of logic so here's what this version
of the program is doing it's moving Yale
by default to zero zero just to
arbitrarily put it somewhere pointing at
Direction 90 degrees which means just
horizontally essentially and then it's
forever doing this if touching the left
wall or touching the right wall here's
our translation of Bounce we're just
turning 180 degrees and the nice thing
about that is we don't have to worry if
we're going from right to left or left
to right 180 degrees is going to work on
both of the walls and that's it
after we do that we just move one step
one pixel at a time but we're doing it
forever so something is happening
continually and the Yale icon is
bouncing back and forth well one final
piece here what if now we want a more uh
another adversary a more advanced
adversary down the road for instance to
go and follow us wherever we are such
that this time
we want
the other Sprite
to not just bounce back and forth but
literally follow us no matter where we
go
how might this be implemented
on the screen I bet it's another forever
block but what's inside
yeah forever point at the location of
the Harvard shield and go one step
toward it this is just going to go on
forever if I just give up at least in
this version notice it's about it's sort
of twitching back and forth because it
goes one pixel then one pixel then one
pixel it's sort of in a frantic State
here we haven't finished the game yet
but if we see inside we'll see exactly
that it didn't take much to implement
this simple idea go to a random position
just to make it kind of fair initially
then forever Point towards Harvard which
is what we call the Harvard Crest spray
move one step suppose we now wanted to
make a more advanced level what's a
minor change I could logically make to
this code just to make MIT even better
at this
all right change the number of steps to
two so let's try that so now they got
twice as fast let me go ahead and just
get this out of the way whoops let me
make it a fair fight
green flag
all right I unfortunately am still
moving one pixel at a time so this isn't
going to end well it caught up to me and
if we're really aggressive
and do something like 20 steps at a time
click the green flag Jesus okay so
that's how you might then make your
levels progressively harder and harder
so it's not an accident that we chose
these particular examples here involving
these particular schools because we have
one more demonstration we thought we'd
introduce today if we could get one
other volunteer to come up and play what
was called by one of your predecessors
Ivy's hardest game let's see Hugh in the
middle do you want to come on up what's
your name
let's say again
it comes a little closer actually sorry
hard to hear here
all right a round of applause here if we
could too
okay sorry what was your name
Celeste Celeste come on over nice to
meet you too so here we have on this
other screen Ivy's hardest game written
by a former cs50 student I think you'll
see that it combines these same
principles the maze is clearly a little
more advanced the goal at hand is to
initially move the Harvard Crest to the
Sprite all the way on the right so that
you catch up to him in this case but
you'll see that there's different levels
and different levels of sophistication
so if you're up for you can use just
these arrow keys up down left right
you'll be controlling the Harvard Sprite
and if we could raise the volume just a
little bit we'll make this our final
example
there we go clicking the green flag
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
that's it for cs50 Welcome to the class
we'll see you next time
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right so this is cs50 and this is
week one the one in which you learn a
new language which is something we
technically said last week at least if
you had never played with this graphical
language known as scratch before which
itself was a programming language but
today is promised we transitioned to
something a little more traditional a
little more text-based not puzzle piece
or block based known as C this is an
older language it's been around for
decades but it's a language that
underlies so many of today's more modern
languages among them something called
python that will also come to in a few
weeks time indeed at the end of the
semester the goal is for you to feel
that you've not learned scratch you've
not learned C or even python for that
matter but fundamentally that you've
learned how to program unfortunately
when you learn how to program with a
more traditional language like this
there's just so much distraction last
week I described all of the syntax all
of the weird punctuation that you see in
this like the hash symbol these angle
brackets parentheses curly braces
backslash n and more well today we're
not going to reveal what all of those
little particulars mean but by next week
will this no longer look like the
proverbial Greek to you a language that
presumably you've never actually seen or
typed before but to do that we'll
explore some of the very same topics
since last week so recall that via
scratch and presumably by a problem set
one we took a look at things called
functions that are actions or verbs and
related to functions where arguments
like inputs and related to some
functions were return values like
outputs then we talked a bit about
conditionals Forks in the road so to
speak Boolean Expressions which are just
yes no questions or true false questions
Loops which let you do things again and
again variables like in math that let
you store values temporarily and then
even other topics still so if you were
comfortable on the heels of problems at
zero in last week realize that all of
these topics are going to be remained
with us so really today is just about
acquiring all the more of a mental model
for how you translate those ideas into
presumably a very cryptic new syntax a
new syntax frankly that's actually more
simple in some ways than your own human
language be it English or something else
because there's far fewer vocabulary
words there's actually far less syntax
that you might have in say a typical
human language but you need to be with
these computer languages all the more
precise so that your most uh ultimately
correct and ultimately we'll see too
your code is successful along a few
other lines as well so if you think
about like the last time you kind of
wandered around not really knowing what
you were doing or encountered something
new might not have been that long ago
entering Harvard Yard for the very first
time or old campus or the light be it in
Cambridge or New Haven you know you
didn't really need to know how to do
everything as a first year you didn't
need to know who everyone was where
everything was Hal Harvard or Yale or
anything else for that matter worked you
sort of got by day to day by just
focusing on those things that matter and
anything you didn't really understand
you sort of turned a blind eye to until
it's important and that's indeed what
we're going to do today and really for
the next several weeks we'll focus on
details that are initially important and
try to wave our hands so to speak it
details that yeah eventually we'll get
to might be interesting but for now they
might be distractions and by
distractions I really mean some of that
syntax to which I alluded earlier so by
the end of today and really by the end
of problem set one your first foray
presumably into this language called C
you'll have written some code and you'll
be asking yourself We'll be asking
yourselves just how good is that code
well first and foremost per last week be
it in scratch or phone book form like
code ultimately needs to be correct to
be Well Done Right you want the problem
to be solved correctly so that one sort
of goes without saying and along the way
this term will provide you with tools
and techniques so you don't have to just
sit there sort of endlessly trying an
input checking the output trying another
input checking the output there's a lot
of automation tools in the real world
and in this class and others like it
that'll help facilitate you answering
that question for yourself is my code
correct according to our specifications
or the like but then something that's
going to take more time and you're
probably not going to feel 100
comfortable with the first week the
first weeks is just how well designed
your code is it's one thing to sort sort
of speak English or write English but
it's another thing or any language for
that matter but it's another thing to
speak it or write it well and we spend
all these years in middle school high
school presumably writing papers and
other documents getting grades and
feedback on them as to how well
formulated your arguments were how well
structured your paper was and the like
and there's that same idea in
programming it doesn't matter
necessarily that you've just solved the
program a problem correctly if your code
is a complete visual mess or if it's
crazy long it's going to be really hard
for someone else to wrap their mind
around what your code is doing and
indeed to be confident if it is correct
and honestly you the next morning the
next year the next time you look at that
code might have no idea what you
yourself were even thinking but you will
if you focus too on designing good code
getting your algorithms efficient
getting your code nice and clean and
even making sure your code looks pretty
which would describe as a matter of
style so in the sort of written human
world you know having punctuation in the
right place capitalization and like the
sort of way you write an essay but not
necessarily send a text message relates
to style for instance and so good style
and code is going to have a few of these
characteristics that are pretty easily
taught and remembered but you just have
to start to get in the habit of writing
code in a certain way so these three
axes so to speak correctness design and
style are really the overarching goals
when writing code that ultimately is
going to look like this so this program
we conjectured last week does what if
you run it on a Mac or PC or somewhere
else presumably
what does it do yeah
it just prints hello world and honestly
that's kind of atrocious that you need
to hit your keyboard keys this many
times with this cryptic syntax just to
get a program to say hello world so a
spoiler in a few weeks time when we
introduce other more modern languages
like python you can distill this same
logic into literally one line of code
and so we're getting there ultimately
but it's in it's helpful to understand
what it is that's going on here because
even though this is a pretty cryptic
syntax there's nothing after this week
and really next week that you shouldn't
be able to understand even about
something that right now looks a little
something like this so how do you write
code well I've given us sort of the
answer to a problem how do you print
hello world on the screen so what do I
do with this code well we're in the
habit of typically writing things with
like Microsoft Word or Google documents
and yeah I could open up word or Google
Docs or Pages or the like and just
literally transcribe that character for
character save it and boom I've got a
program but the problem per last week is
that computers only understand or speak
what other language so to speak
yeah so binary zeros and ones and so
this obviously is not zeros and one so
it doesn't matter if I put it in a word
dot Google doc Pages file or the like
the computer's not going to understand
it until I somehow translate it to zeros
and ones and honestly none of those
tolls that I rattled off are really
appropriate for programming why well
they come with features like bold facing
and italics and sort of fluffy aesthetic
stuff that has no functional impact on
what you're trying to do with your code
and they don't have the ability it would
seem to convert that code ultimately to
zeros and ones but tools that do have
this capability might be called
integrated development environments or
Ides or more simply text editors a text
editor is a tool that a programmer uses
perhaps every day to write their code
and it's a simple program here for
instance a very popular one called
Visual Studio code or vs code and at the
top here you see that I've actually
created in advance before class A very
simple empty file called hello.c why
well dot C indicates by convention that
this is going to be a file file in which
there is C code it's not DOT docx which
would mean in this file is a Microsoft
Word document or dot pages is a Pages
file this is dot C which means in this
file is going to be text in the language
called C this number one here is just
sort of an automatic line number that's
going to help me keep track of how long
or short this program is and the cursor
is just blinking there waiting for me to
start typing some code well let me go
ahead and type out exactly the same code
for me it comes pretty comfortably from
memory so I'm going to go ahead and
include something called standard io.h
more on that later I'm going to sort of
magically type int main void whatever
that means we'll come back to that later
one of these curly braces and then a
sibling there that closes the same then
I'm going to hit tab to indent a few
spaces and then I'm going to type not
print but print f
then hello comma World backslash n close
quote close parenthesis semicolon and I
dare say this was essentially the very
first program I wrote some 25 years ago
I wrote it to say hi cs50 now it just
says the more canonical conventional
hello world but that's it that's my very
first program and all I need to now do
is maybe hit command s or control s to
save the file and voila I am a
programmer
the catch though is like okay how do I
run this like on your Mac or PC how do
you run a program we'll usually double
click an icon on your phone you tap an
icon in this environment that we're
using and that many programmers there
say most programmers use you don't have
immediately a nice pretty icon to double
click on that's very user friendly but
it's not very necessary especially when
you get more comfortable with
programming you're going to want to type
commands because it's just faster than
pointing and clicking a mouse and you're
going to want to automate things which
is a lot easier if it's all command or
text based as opposed to Mouse and mus
muscular movements and so here I have my
program it lives in this file called
hello.c I need to now convert it though
to zeros and ones well how do I go about
doing this and how am I going to get
from those uh this so-called code or
source code as it's conventionally
called to this these zeros and ones that
will now start calling machine code the
zeros and ones from last week can be
used not only to represent numbers and
letter Colors audio video and more it
can also represent instructions to a
computer like print or play a sound or
delete a file or save a file all the
sort of basics of a computer somehow can
be represented by other patterns of
zeros and ones and just like last week
it depends on the context in which these
numbers are stored sometimes they're
interpreted as numbers like in a
spreadsheet sometimes they're
interpreted as colors sometimes they're
interpreted as instructions commands to
your computer to do very low level
operations like print something on the
screen
so fortunately like last week's
definition of like computer science of
problem solving is a nice mental model
for exactly the goal at hand I have some
input AKA source code I want to Output
ultimately machine code those zeros and
Wands I certainly don't want to do this
kind of process by hand so hopefully
there's an algorithm implemented by some
special program that does exactly that
and those of you who do have some prior
experience this program might be called
a
a compiler so a few of you have indeed
programmed before not all languages use
compiler C in fact is a language that
does use a compiler and so I just need
to find myself on my computer somewhere
presumably a so-called compiler a
program whose purpose in life is to
convert one language to another and
source code intextually in C like we saw
a moment ago is source code the machine
code is the corresponding zeros and ones
so let me go back to the same
programming environment called Visual
Studio code or vs code this is typically
a program you or any programmer on the
internet can download onto their own Mac
or PC and be on their way with whatever
computer you own writing some code a
downside though of that approach is that
all of us have slightly different
versions of Macs or PCS we have slightly
different versions of operating systems
they may or may not be up to date it's
just sort of a technical support
nightmare to create a uniform
environment especially for like an
introductory class where everyone should
ideally be on the same page so we can
get you up and running quickly and so
I'm actually using a cloud-based version
of vs code something that you only need
a browser to access and then you can be
on any computer today or tomorrow by the
end of the semester we're going to get
you out of the cloud so to speak as best
we can and get you onto your own Mac or
PC so that after this class especially
if it's the only CS class you ever take
you feel like you can continue
programming in any number of languages
even with cs50 behind you but for now
wonderfully the browser version of BS
code should pretty much be identical to
what the eventual downloadable version
of the same would be and you'll see in
problem set one how to access this and
how to get going yourself with your
first programs
but I haven't mentioned this bottom part
of the screen this bottom part of the
screen and this is an area where we have
what's called a terminal window so this
is sort of old school technology that
allows you with a keyboard to interact
with a computer wherever it may be on
your lap in your pocket or even in this
case in the cloud so on the top hand
portion of this screen is my code my
text editor like tabbed Windows like in
many programs so I can just create files
and write code the bottom of the screen
here my so-called terminal window gives
me the ability to run commands on a
server that currently I have exclusive
access to so because I logged into vs
code with my account online I have my
own sort of virtual server if you will
in the cloud otherwise known as in this
context a container this has its own
operating system for me its own hard
drive if you will where I can save and
create files of my own separate from
yours and vice versa and it's at this
very simple prompt which is
conventionally but not always
abbreviated by a dollar sign has nothing
to do with currency it just means type
your commands here this is where I'm
going to be able to type commands like
compile my source code into machine code
so it's a command line interface or CLI
on top of an operating system that you
might not have ever used or seen but
it's very popular called Linux odds are
almost all of us in this room are using
Mac OS or Windows right now but we're
all going to start using an operating
system called Linux which is in a family
of operating systems that offer not only
this command line interface but are used
not just for programming but for serving
websites and developing applications and
the like and it's indeed a familiar and
very powerful interface as we'll see so
how do I go about making this file
hello.c into a program there's no double
there's no icon to double click but
there is a command I can type make hello
at this dollar sign prompt go ahead and
hit enter and nothing appears to happen
but that's a good thing and as we'll see
in programming almost always if you
don't see anything go wrong that means
everything went right so this is going
to be a rarity at first but this is a
good thing that it just seems to do
nothing but now there is in the folder
in my account in this on the cloud a
file called hello and it's a bit of a
weird command but you'll get familiar
with it before long dot just means go
into my current folder
slash Hello means run the program called
hello in this current folder so dot
slash hello and then enter and voila now
I'm actually not just programming but
running my actual code
so what have I just done let me go ahead
and do this I'm going to go ahead and
open up the sidebar of this program and
you'll see in problem set one how to do
this and this might look a little
different based on your own
configuration even the color scheme I'm
using might ultimately look different
from yours because it supports nice
colorful theme so you can have different
colors and uh brightnesses depending on
your mood or the time of day what I've
opened here though is what is called in
vs code Explorer and this is just all of
the files in my cloud account and
there's not many right now there's only
two one is the file called hello.c and
it's highlighted because I've got it
open right there and the other is a file
called hello which is brand new and was
created when I ran that command and
what's now worth noting is that now
things are getting a little more like
Mac OS and windows like on the left hand
side you have a GUI a graphical user
interface but on the bottom here again
you have a CLI command line interface
these are just different ways to
interact with computers and you'll get
comfortable with both and honestly
you're certainly familiar and with
gooeys already so it's the command line
one with which we'll spend some time now
suppose that I just wanted to do
something more than compile this program
suppose I wanted to go ahead and remove
it like uh no I made a mistake I want to
say hello cs50 not Hello World I could
just hover up here like in any software
and I could right click and I could poke
around in there delete permanently so
most of us might have that instinct on a
Mac or PC you right click or control
click and you poke around but in a
command line interface let me do this
instead the command for removing or
deleting a file in the world of Linux
this other operating system is just to
type RM for remove and then hello enter
it's a somewhat cryptic confirmation
message but this just means are you sure
I'm going to go ahead and type y for yes
and now when I hit enter Watch What
Happens at top left in the Explorer the
GUI the graphical interface voila it
disappears right not terribly exciting
but this just means this is a graphical
version of what we're seeing here and it
fact if you want to never use the GUI
again I'll go ahead and close it with a
keyboard shortcut here you can forever
just type LS for list and hit enter and
you will see in the command line
interface all of the files in your
current folder so anything you can do
with a mouse you can do with this
command line interface and indeed we'll
see many more things that you can do as
well but the inventors of this and it's
uh this operating system is predecessors
we're very succinct like the command is
RM for remove the command is LS for list
it's very terse why because it's just
faster to type
so before we Forge ahead with making
something more interesting than just
hello world let me pause here to see if
there's questions on source code or
machine code or compiler or this command
line interface
really good question and let me recap if
I were to make changes to the program
run it and maybe make other changes and
try to rerun it would those changes be
reflected even though I've reworded
slightly well let's do this I already
removed the old version so let me go
ahead and point out that if I do dot
slash hello now I'm going to see some
kind of error because I just deleted the
file
no such file or directory so it's not
terribly user friendly but it's saying
what the problem is let me go ahead and
remake it by typing make hello now if I
type LS I'll see not one but two files
again and one of them is even green with
a little asterisk to indicate that it's
executable it's sort of the textual
version of something you could double
click in our human world so now of
course if I run hello we're back where I
started hello world but now suppose I
change it to hello comma cs50 like I did
years ago let me go ahead and save the
file with command s or control s down
here now let me run dot slash hello
again and voila
huh
so let me ask someone else to answer
that question what's the missing step
why did it not say hello cs50 yeah
yeah so you didn't I didn't compile it
again so sort of newbie mistake you're
going to make this mistake and many
others before long but now let me go
ahead and remake hello enter it's going
to seemingly make uh the same program
but this time when I run it it's hello
cs50
or any other questions on
some of these building blocks and we'll
come back to all the crazy syntax I
typed before long but for now we're
focusing on just the output yeah
uh when I keep running make it creates a
new version of the machine code so it
keeps changing the hello program and the
hello file and that's it there's no make
file per se
ah good question no if I open up that
directory you'll see that there's just
the one and it doesn't matter how many
times I run make hello three four five
it just keeps overwriting the original
so it's kind of like just saving in the
world of Google docs or Microsoft Word
or the like but there's an additional
step today we have to then convert my
words to the computers the zeros and
ones
yeah in front
ah what happens if I run hello.c so let
me go ahead and do dot slash hello.c
which is a mistake you'll invariably
make early on permission denied so what
does that mean this is where the error
message is mean something to the people
who design the operating system but it's
a little cryptic it's not that you don't
have access to the file it means that
it's not executable this is not it's
something you have permission to run but
you do have permission to read or write
it that is change it
ah really good question so if I have
named my file hello.c or more generally
something.c one of the things that make
does is it automatically picks the file
name for me and we'll discuss a bit
we'll discuss this a bit more next week
make itself is kind of the first of
White Lies today itself is not a
compiler it's a program that knows how
to find and use the compiler on the
system and automatically create the
program if I use as we'll discuss next
week the actual compiler myself I have
to type a much longer sequence of
commands to specify explicitly what do I
want the name of my program to be make
is a nice program especially in week one
because it just automates all of that
for us and so here we have now a program
that very simply prints something on the
screen so let's now put this into the
context of where we left off last time
in the context of scratch and inputs and
outputs so we discussed last time of
course functions and arguments functions
again are those actions and verbs like
say or ask or the like and the arguments
were the inputs to those functions
generally in those little white ovals
that in scratch you could type words or
numbers into well C in all of the
languages we're going to see this term
have that same capability and let's just
start to translate one of these things
to another so for instance let's put
this same program in C in the context of
scratch this is what hello world looked
like last week in the form of one
function this week of course it looks
like print and then the parentheses
notice are kind of deliberately designed
in the world of scratch to resemble that
same shape even though this is a white
oval you kind of get that
um it's uh it's kind of evoking that
same idea with the parentheses
technically the function in C it's not
called say it's not even called print
it's called print F the F stands for
formatted but we'll see what that means
in a moment but printf is the closest
analogous function for say in the world
of C notice if though you want to print
something like hello world or hello cs50
in C you don't just write the words as
we did last week you also had to add
what if you notice already what's
missing from this version
yeah so the double quotes on the left
and the right so that's necessary in C
whenever you have a a string of words
and I'm using that word deliberately
whenever you have multiple words like
this this is known as a string as we'll
see and you have to put it in double
quotes not single quotes you have to put
it in double quotes there's one other
stupid thing that we need to have in my
C code in order to get this function to
do something ultimately which is what
semicolon so just like in our human
world you eventually got into the habit
of using at least informal writing
periods semicolon is generally what you
use to finish your thought in the world
of programming with c all right so we
have that function in place now what
does this really fit into in terms of
the mental model well functions take
arguments and it turns out functions can
have different types of outputs and
we've actually seen both already last
week one type of output from a function
can be something called a side effect
and it generally refers to something
visual like something appearing on the
screen or a sound playing from your
computer it's sort of a side effect of
the function doing its thing and indeed
last week we saw this in the context of
passing in a something like hello world
as input to the save function and we saw
on the screen hello world but it was
kind of a one-off it's it's one and done
you can't actually do anything with that
visual output other than consume it
visually with your human eyes but
sometimes recall last week we had
functions like the ask block that
actually returned me some value remember
the ask what's your name it handed me
back whatever answer the human typed in
it didn't just arbitrarily display it on
the screen the cat didn't necessarily
say it on the screen it was stored
instead in that special variable
that was called answer because some
functions have not side effects but
return values they hand you back an
output that you can use and reuse unlike
the side effect which again displays and
that's it you can't sort of catch it and
hold on to it so in the context of last
week we had the ask block and that had
this special answer return value in C
we're going to see in just a moment we
could translate this as follows the
closest match I can propose for the ask
block is a function that we're going to
start calling get string string is again
a word a set of words like a phrase or a
sentence in programming it too is a
function insofar as it takes input and
pretty much this isn't always true but
very often when you have a word in C
followed by an open parenthesis and a
closed parenthesis it's most likely the
name of a function and we're going to
see that there's some exceptions to that
but for now this indeed looks like a
function because it matches that pattern
if I want to ask the question what's
your name question mark and I'm even
going to deliberately put a space there
just to kind of move the cursor a little
bit over so that the human isn't typing
literally after the question mark so
that's just the nitpicky aesthetic this
is perhaps the closest analog to just
asking that question but because the ask
block returns a value the analog here
forget string is that it too returns a
value it doesn't just print the human's
input it hands it back to you in the
form of a variable AKA a return value
that I can then use and reuse
now ideally it would be as simple as
this literally saying answer on the left
equals and this is where things start to
diverge from math and sort of our human
world this equal sign henceforth is not
the equal sign it is the assignment
operator to assign a value means to
store a value in some variable and you
read these things weirdly right to left
so here is a function called get string
I claim that it's going to return to you
whatever the human types in is their
name
it's going to get stored over here on
the left because of this so-called
assignment operator that yes is an equal
sign but it doesn't mean equality in
this context it makes things equal but
it does so by copying the value on the
right into the thing on the left
unfortunately we're not quite done yet
with c and this is where again it gets a
little Annoying at first where a scratch
just let us express our ideas without so
much syntax
in C when you have a variable you don't
just give it a name like you did in
scratch you also have to tell the
computer in advance what type of value
it is storing
string is one such type of value int for
integer is going to be another and
there's even more than that that we'll
see today and Beyond and this is partly
an answer to the question that came up
one or more times last week which was
how does a computer distinguish this
pattern of zeros and ones from this like
is this a letter a number a color a
piece of video and I just claimed last
week that it totally depends on the
program it depends on the context and
that's true but within those programs it
often depends on what the human
programmer said the type of the value is
if this specifies it's a string which
means interpret the following zeros and
ones that are stored in my program as
words or letters more generally if it
said int for integer it would be
implying by the programmer treat the
following zeros and ones in my program
as a number an integer not a string so
here's where this week unlike with
scratch which just kind of figures out
what you mean with C in a lot of
languages you have to be this pedantic
and tell it what you mean there's still
one stupid thing missing from my code
here
what's still missing here yeah
and we still need the stupid semicolon
and I'm sort of impuning it here because
honestly these are the kinds of stupid
mistakes you're gonna make today
tomorrow this weekend next week a few
weeks from now until you start to notice
this and recognize it as well as you do
English or whatever your uh spoken
language is Yeah question
good question suppose I mix apples and
oranges so to speak and I try to put a
string in an INT or an INT in a string
the compiler is going to complain so
when I run that make Command as I did
earlier it's not going to be nice and
blissfully quiet and just give me
another prompt it's going to yell at me
with honestly a very cryptic looking
error message until we get the muscle
memory for reading it other questions
um what happened to the backslash n so
we'll come back to that in just a moment
if we may because I have deliberately
omitted it here but we did have it
earlier and we'll see the different
behavior in a sec
other questions
yeah not at all nitpicky these are the
kinds of things that just matter and
it's going to take time to recognize and
develop this muscle memory everything
I've typed here except for the W at the
moment is lowercase and the W is
capitalized just because it's English
everything else is lowercase and this
kind of varies by language and also
context so in many languages the
convention is to use all lowercase
letters for your variable names other
languages might use some capitals as
well but we'll talk about that before
long but this is the kind of thing that
matters and is hard to see at first
especially when a little s doesn't look
that different you know when it's on
your tiny laptop screen from a
capitalist but you'll start to develop
these instincts all right so besides
this particular block let's go ahead and
consider how we can go about
implementing this now in code so let me
switch back to vs code here this was the
program I had earlier and let me go
ahead and undo my cs50 change and this
time just rerun it rerun make on hello
with the original version with the
backslash n enter nothing bad seems to
have happened so dot slash hello enter
hello world now if you're curious this
is a good instinct to start to acquire
what happens if I get rid of this well
I'm probably not going to break things
too badly so let's try let me go ahead
now and do make hello
still compile so it's not a really bad
mistake so let me go ahead and run dot
slash hello
what's the difference here
yeah what do you see that's different
yeah the dollar sign my so-called prompt
stayed on the same line why well we can
presumably infer now that the backslash
n is some fancy notation for saying
create a new line move the cursor so to
speak to the next line notice that the
cursor will move to the next line in my
terminal window if I keep hitting it it
just automatically by nature of hitting
enter does it but it'd be kind of stupid
if when you run a program in this world
simple as it is if like the next command
is now weirdly spaced in the middle of
the terminal with the dollars on it just
looks sloppy right that's it's really
just an aesthetic argument and notice
that it's not acceptable or correct to
do this
to hit enter there let me go ahead and
save that though and see what happens
let me go ahead now and run uh make
hello enter oh my God like four errors
this is like what 10 lines of Errors for
like a one-line program and this is
where again you'll start to develop the
instincts for just reading this stuff
these kinds of tools like the compiler
tool we're using were not designed
necessarily with user friendliness in
mind that's changed over the decades but
certainly early on it's really just
meant to be correct and precise with its
errors so what did I do here missing
terminating close quote character long
story short when you have a string in C
your double quotes just have to be on
the same line just because now there's
the slight white lie there's ways around
this but the Cur best way around it is
to you this use this so-called escape
sequence to escape something means
generally to put a backslash and then a
special symbol like n for new line and
this is just the agreed upon way that
humans decades ago decided okay you
don't just hit your Enter key you
instead put backslash n and that tells
the computer to move the cursor to the
new line
so again kind of cryptic but once you
know it like that's it it's just another
word in our vocabulary so now let me
transition to making my program a little
more interactive instead of just saying
hello world let me change it like last
week to say hello David or whoever's
interacting with the program so I'm
going to do string answer gets get
string quote unquote what's your name
I'm not going to bother with a new line
here I could this is now just a judgment
call I I deliberately want the human to
type their name on the same line just
because
and how do I now print this well last
week recall we used say and then we used
the other block called join so the idea
here is the same but the syntax this
week is going to be a little different
it's going to be printf which prints
something on the screen
I'm going to go ahead and say hello
comma and let me just go with this
initially with the backslash n semicolon
let me go ahead and re-compile my code
whoops
huh damn doesn't work still and look at
all these errors like there's more
errors than code I wrote
but what's going on here well this is
actually something a mistake you'll see
somewhat often at least initially and
let's start to glean what's going on
here so here if I look at the very first
line of output after the dollar sign so
even though it jumped down the screen
pretty fast I wrote make hello at the
dollar sign prompt and then here's the
first error on hello.c line five
technically character five but generally
line is enough to get you going there's
an error use of Undeclared identifier
string did you mean standard in
so I didn't and this is not an obvious
solution at first but you'll start to
recognize these patterns and error
messages it turns out that if I want to
use string I actually have to do this I
have to include another Library up here
another line of code rather called
cs50.h we'll come back to what this
means in just a moment but if I now
retroactively say all right what does
standard i o do for us up here before I
added that new line
what is standard IO doing well if you
think back to scratch there were a few
examples with like the camera and with
the speech to uh the text to voice
remember I had to poke around in like
the extensions button and then I had to
load it into scratch it didn't come
natively with scratch C is quite like
that some functions come with the
language but in for the most part if you
want to use a function an action or verb
like printf you have to load that
extension so to speak that more
traditionally is called a library so
there is a standard i o Library stdio
standard IO where I O just means input
and output which means just like in
mit's World there was an extension for
doing text to voice or for using your
camera in C there's an extension AKA a
library for doing standard input and
output and so if you want to use any
functions related to standard input and
output like keyboard text from a
keyboard
you have to include standardio.h and you
have to then can you use printf
same goes here get string it turns out
is a function that cs50 wrote some time
ago and on as we'll see over the coming
weeks it just makes it way easier to get
input from a user C is very good with
printf at printing output on the screen
C makes it really annoying and hard as
we'll see in a few weeks to just get
input from the user so we wrote a
function called get string but the only
way you can use that is to load the
extension AKA load the library called
cs50 and we'll come back in time like
why is it dot h why is it a hash symbol
but for now
standard i o is a library that gives you
access to printf and input and output
related stuff cs50 is the second library
that provides you with access to
functions that don't come with C that
include something like get string so
with that said
we've now kind of teased apart at a high
level what lines two and now one are
doing let me go ahead and rerun make
hello now it worked so all those crazy
error messages were resolved by just one
fix so key takeaway is not to get
overwhelmed by the sheer number of
Errors let me now do dot slash hello
and if I type in my name what am I going
to say
what do you think
yeah hello answer because the computer
is going to take me literally and it
turns out that if you just write hello
comma answer all in the double quotes
you're really just practicing English as
the input to the printf function you're
not actually passing in the variable and
unfortunately in C it's not quite as
easy to plug things in to other things
that you've typed remember in scratch
there was not just the save block but
the join block which was kind of pretty
it does you go you can combine apples
and oranges or most apple and banana
then we changed it to hello and then the
answer that the human typed in and see
the syntax is going to be a little
different you tell the computer inside
of your double quotes that you want to
have a placeholder there so-called
format code percent s means hey computer
put a string here eventually
then outside of your quotes you just add
a comma and then you type in whatever
variable you want the computer to plug
in at that percent s location for you so
percent s is a format code which serves
as a placeholder and now the printf
function was designed by humans years
ago to figure out how to do the apple
and banana thing of joining two words
together it's not nearly as user
friendly as it is in scratch but it's a
very common Paradigm so let me try and
rerun this now make hello
no errors that's good dot slash hello
what's my name David if I type enter now
now it's hello David and the printf
here's the f in printf it formats its
input for you by using these
placeholders for things like strings
represented Again by
percent s
so a quick question then if I focus here
on line seven for just a moment and even
zoom in here
how many inputs is printf taking as a
function a moment ago I'd admit that it
was taking one input hello world quote
unquote how many inputs might you infer
printf is taking now
two and it's implied by this comma here
which is separating the first one quote
unquote hello percent s from the second
one answer and then just as a quick
safety check here why is it not three
because there's obviously two commas
here
why is it not actually three arguments
or inputs
exactly the comma in the to the left is
actually part of my English grammar
that's all so same syntax and again
here's where again programming can just
be confusing early on because we're
using the same special punctuation to
mean different things it just depends on
the context and so now is actually a
good time to point out all of the
somewhat pretty colors that have been
popping up on the screen here even
though I wasn't going to like a format
menu I wasn't bold facing things I
certainly wasn't changing things to red
or blue or whatnot that's because a text
editor like vs code
syntax highlights for you this is a
feature of so many different programming
environments nowadays vs code does it as
well if your text editor understands the
language that you're programming in see
in this case it highlights in different
colors the different types of ideas in
your code so for instance string and
answer here are in black but get string
a function is in this uh sort of nasty
Brown yellow here right now but that's
just how it's displays on the screen the
screen though here and red is kind of
jumping out at me and that's marginally
useful the percent s is in blue that's
kind of nice because it's jumping out at
me and so it's just using different
colors to make different things on the
screen pop so you can focus on how these
ideas interrelate and honestly when you
might make a mistake for instance let me
accidentally leave off this quote here
and now all of a sudden everything
notice if I delete the quote the colors
start to get a little awry
but if I go back there and put it back
now everything's back in place what's
another feature of this text editor
notice when my cursor is next to this
parenthesis which demarcates the end of
the inputs to the function notice that
highlighted in green here is the opening
parenthesis why it's just a visually
useful thing especially when you start
writing more and more code just to make
sure your parentheses are lining up and
that's true for these curly braces over
here on the left and the right we'll
come back to those in a moment if I put
my cursor there you can see that these
things correspond to one another so it's
nothing in your code fundamentally it's
just the editor trying to help you the
human program and you can even see it
though it's a little subtle see these
four dots here and these four dots here
that's my indentation I'm configured vs
code to indent by four spaces which is a
very common convention anytime I hit the
Tab Key this too can help you make sure
once we have more interesting and longer
programs
that everything lines up nice and neatly
all right any questions then on printf
or more yeah
short answer yes printf can handle more
than one type of variable or value
percent s is one we're going to see
percent I as another for plugging in an
integer you can have multiple I's
multiple S's and even other symbols too
we'll come back to that in just a little
bit printf can take many more arguments
than just these two this is just meant
to be representative
yeah over here
can you declare variables within the
printf no the variables the only
variable I'm using right now is answer
and it's got to be done outside the
context of printf in this case good
question we'll see more of that before
long
uh yeah in back
how do we download the cs50 library so
uh we will show you in problem set one
exactly how to do that it's
automatically done for you in our
version of vs code in the cloud if
ultimately you program on your own Mac
or PC either initially or later on it's
also installable online but if you want
to ask that
um a via online or afterward we can
point you in the right direction but
pset one will itself yeah
string is the type of the variable or
the more properly the data type of the
variable int is another keyword I
alluded to earlier I haven't used it yet
int for integer is going to be another
type or data type of variable
yeah
ah good question could I go ahead and
just plug in this function kind of like
we did in scratch getting rid of the
variable altogether and just do this
which recall is reminiscent of what I
did in Scratch by plopping block on top
of block on block am I answering that
right
can I put string in front of get string
no you only put the word string in front
of a variable that you want to make
string and even though I'm apparently
answering the wrong question let me go
ahead and zoom out save this do make
hello again seems to compile okay if I
run dot slash Hello type in David voila
that too works and so actually let's go
down this rabbit hole for just a moment
clearly it's still correct at least
based on my limited testing
is this better designed or Worse design
let's open that question like we did
last week yeah
yeah I kind of agree with that um
reasonable people could disagree but I I
do agree that this seems harder to read
because like I have to I start reading
here but wait a minute get string is
going to get used first and then it's
going to give me back a value so yeah it
just feels like it was nicer to read top
to bottom I would say your thoughts
yeah and so this is useful if I only
want to print out the person's name once
if I want to use it later in a longer
program I'm out of luck and so I haven't
saved it in a variable so I think long
story short we could sort of debate this
all day long but in this case yeah like
if you can make a reasonable argument
one way or the other like that's a
pretty solid ground to stand on but
invariably reasonable people are going
to disagree with their first time
programmers or many years after that so
let's frame this one last example in the
context of the same process of taking
inputs and outputs the functions we've
been talking about all take inputs
otherwise now known as arguments or
parameters pretty much synonymous that's
just the fancy word for an input to a
function and some functions have either
side effects like we saw printing
something saying something on the screen
sort of visually or audibly or they
return a value which is a reusable value
like name or answer in this case if we
look then at what we did last time in
the world of scratch last week the input
was what's your name the function was
asked and the return value was answer
and now let's take a look at this block
which is honestly a more user-friendly
version of what we just did with the
percent s last week we said say then
join then hello and answer but the
interesting takeaway there was not how
to say hello anything it was the fact
that in Scratch 2 the output of one
function like the green join could
become the input to another function the
purple say the syntax in C is admittedly
pretty different but the idea is
essentially the same here though we have
hello a placeholder but we have to in
this world of C tell printf what we want
to plug in for that placeholder it's
just different but that's the way to do
it when we get to Python and other
languages later in the term there's
actually easier ways to do this but this
is a very common Paradigm particularly
when you want to format your data in
some way all right let's then take a
step back to where we began which was
with that whole program which had the
include and it had int main void and all
of this other cryptic syntax
this scratch piece last week was kind of
like the go-to whenever you want to have
a main part of your program it's not the
only way to start a scratch program you
could listen for clicks or other things
not just the green flag but this was
probably the most popular place to start
a program in scratch
in C the closest analog is to literally
write this out so just like last week if
you were in the habit of dragging and
dropping when green flag clicked as a c
programmer the first thing you would do
is after creating an empty file like I
did with hello.c you'd probably type int
main void open curly brace curly brace
and then you can put all of your code
inside of those curly braces so just
like scratch had this sort of magnetic
nature to it where the puzzle pieces
would snap together C is a text-based
language tends to use these curly braces
one of them opened the other one closed
and anything inside of those braces so
to speak is part of this puzzle piece
AKA Main
so what was atop them we went down this
Rabbit Hole a moment ago with these
things called header files even though I
didn't call them by this name but indeed
when we have a whole program in scratch
super easy just have the one green flag
clicked and then say hello world there's
no special syntax after all it's meant
to be very user friendly and graphical
in C though you technically can't just
put in main void printf hello world you
also need this because again you need to
tell the compiler to load the library
code that someone else will wrote so
that the compiler knows what printf even
is you have to load the cs50 library
whenever you want to use get string or
other functions like get int as we'll
soon see otherwise the compiler won't
know what get string is you just have to
do it this way the specific file name
I'm mentioning here
standardio.h cs50.h is what C
programmers called a call a header file
we'll see eventually what's inside of
those files but long story short it's
like a menu of all of the available
functions so in cs50.8 there's a menu
mentioning get string get int and a
bunch of other stuff and in as
standardio.h there's a menu of functions
among which are printf and that menu is
what prepares the compiler to know how
to implement those same functions
all right let me pause here question
a not quite a library provides all of
the functionality we're talking about a
header file is the very specific
mechanism via which you include it and
we'll discuss this more next week for
now they're essentially the same but
we'll discuss nuances between the two
next week
yeah the library would be standard i o
the library would be cs50 the
corresponding header file is
standardio.h cs50.h
indeed other questions yeah
indeed I that too is on the menu we'll
come back to that but the word string
incredibly common in the world of
programming it's not a cs50 idea but in
C there's technically no such data type
as string by default we have sort of
conjured it up to simplify the first few
weeks that's a training wheel that will
vary deliberately in a few weeks take
away and we'll see why we've even been
using get string and string because C
otherwise makes things uh quite uh quite
more challenging early on which then
gets besides the point for us yeah
yes early on you will have to use
whatever's prescribed by the
specification that will include cs50s
functions long story short you referred
I think a moment ago to another function
called scanf we won't talk about for a
few weeks long story short in C it's
pretty easy and possible to get input
from a user the catch is that it's
really easy to do it dangerously and C
because it's an older lower level
language so to speak that gives you
pretty much all ultimate control over
your computer's Hardware it's very easy
to make mistakes and indeed
um that's to why we use the library so
your code won't crash unintendedly
all right so with this in mind we have
this now mapping between the scratch
version and the other let me just give
you a quick tour of some of the other
placeholders and data types that we'll
soon start seeing as we assemble more
interesting programs in the world of
Linux here is a non-exhaustive list of
commands with which you'll get familiar
over the next few weeks by playing with
problem sets we've only seen two of
these so far LS for list RM for others
but I mentioned them now just so that it
doesn't feel too foreign when you see
them on screen or online in a problem
set CP is going to stand for copy make
dur is going to stand for make directory
MV is going to stand for move or rename
rmdur is going to be remove directory
and CD is going to be for change
directory and let me show you this last
one here first only because it's
something you'll use so commonly if I go
back to my code here on the screen
I'm going to go ahead and reopen the
little GUI on the left hand side the
so-called Explorer revealing that I've
got two files hello and hello.c so
nothing has changed since there suppose
now that you know it's a few weeks into
class and I want to start organizing the
code I'm writing so that I have a folder
for this week or next week or maybe a
folder for problem set one problem set
two I can do this in a few ways in the
GUI I can go up here and do what most of
you would do instinctively on a Mac or
PC you look for like a folder icon you
click it and then you name a folder like
pset1 enter voila you've got a folder
called pset1 I can confirm as much with
my command line interface by typing what
command
how can I list what's in my folder yeah
so LS for list and now I see Hello and
it's green with an asterisk because
that's my executable my runnable program
hello.c which is my source code and now
pset one with a slash at the end which
just implies that it's indeed a folder
all right I didn't really want to do it
that way I'd like to do it more uh
Advanced so let me go ahead and right
click on pset one delete permanently I
get a scary irreversible error message
but there's nothing in it so that's fine
now I've deleted it using the GUI but
now let me go ahead and start
doing the same thing from the command
line and if you're wondering how things
keep disappearing if you hit Ctrl l in
your terminal window or explicitly type
clear it will delete everything you
previously typed just to kind of clean
things up in practice you don't need to
be doing this often I'm doing it just to
keep our focus on my latest commands if
I do what was the command to make a new
directory
yeah so make dur make directory let me
create pset one enter and notice it left
there's my piece at one if I want to get
a little overzealous planned for next
week here's my pset 2 directory suppose
now I want to open those folders one on
Mac or PC or in this GUI I could double
click on it like this and you'd see this
little arrow is moving it's not doing
anything because there's nothing in
there but that's fine but suppose again
I want to get more comfortable with my
command line notice if I type LS now I
see all four same things let me change
directories with CD
with CD Space pset 1 enter and now
notice two things will have happened one
my prompt has changed slightly to remind
me where I am just to keep me sane so
that I don't forget what folder I'm
actually in so here is just a visual
reminder of what folder I'm currently in
if I type LS now what should I see after
hitting enter
nothing because I've only created empty
folders so far and indeed I see nothing
if I wanted to create a folder called
Mario for a program that might be called
Mario this week I can do that now if I
type LS there's Mario now if I do CD
Mario notice my prompt is going to
change to be a little more precise now
I'm in peace at one slash Mario and
notice what's happening at top left
nothing now because these folders are
collapsed but if I click the Little
Triangle there I see Mario nothing's
going on in there because there's no
files yet but suppose now I want to
create a file called mario.c
I could go up here I could click the
little plus icon and use the GUI or I
can just type code mario.c voila that
creates a new tab for me I'm not going
to write any code in here yet but I am
going to save the file and now at top
left you'll see that mario.c appears so
at some point you can eventually just
close the Explorer because again it's
not providing you with any new
information it's maybe more user
friendly but there's nothing you can't
do at the command line that you could do
with the GUI
all right but now I'm kind of stuck how
do I get out of this folder in my Mac or
PC World I'd probably click the back
button or something like that or just
close it and start all over in the
terminal window I can do CD dot dot dot
dot is a nickname if you will for The
Parent Directory that is the previous
directory so if I hit enter now notice
I'm going to close the Mario folder AKA
directory and now I'm back in pset one
or if I want to be fancy let me go back
into Mario temporarily if I type LS
there's mario.c just to orient us if I
want to do multiple things at a time I
could do CD slash CD dot dot slash dot
dot which goes to my parent to my
grandparent all in one breath and voila
now I'm back in my default folder if you
will and one last little trick of the
trade if I'm in P set one slash Mario
like I was a moment ago and you're just
tired of all the navigation if you just
type CD and hit enter it'll whisk you
away back to your default folder and you
don't have to worry about getting there
manually recall a bit ago though that I
was running hello as this dot slash
hello
if dot dot refers to my parent perhaps
infer here syntactically what does a
single dot mean instead
it means this directory your current
directory why is that necessary it just
makes super explicit to the computer
that I want the program called hello
that's installed here not in some random
other folder on my hard drive so to
speak I want the one that's right here
instead all right so besides these
commands there's going to be others that
we encounter over time those are kind of
the basics that allows you to sort of
wean yourself off of a GUI graphical
user interface and start using more
comfortably with practice and time a
command line interface instead well what
about those other types now back in the
world of c those commands were not c
those are just commands specific to a
command line interface like in Linux
which again we're using in the cloud
it's an alternative to Mac OS and
windows back in the world of C now we've
seen strings which are words I mentioned
int or integer but there's others as
well in the world of C we've seen string
we will see int if you want a bigger
integer there's something literally
called along if you Want A Single
Character there's something called a
Char if you want a Boolean value true or
false there is a bull and if you want a
floating point value a fancy way of
saying a real number something with a
decimal point in it that is what C and
other languages call a float and if you
want even more numbers after the decimal
point that is more Precision you can use
something called a double
that is to say here is again an example
in programming where it's up to you now
to provide the computer with hints
essentially that it will rely on to know
that what is this pattern of zeros and
ones is it a number a letter is it a a
sound an image a color or the like these
are the types of data types that provide
exactly those hints
what are the functions that come in the
menu that is the cs50 library we talked
about standard i o and that's just one
function so far printf in the cs50
library you can see that it follows a
pattern the cs50 library exists largely
for the first few weeks of the class to
make our lives easier when you got when
you just want to get user input so if
you want to get a string like word or
words from the human you use get string
if you want to get an integer from the
user you're going to use get int when
you want to get any of those other data
types for the most part you use get
underscore something else and they're
indeed all lower case by convention what
about printf if we have the ability now
to store different types of data and we
have functions with which to get
different types of data how might you go
about printing different types of data
well we've seen percent s for string
percent I for integer percent C for Char
percent f for a float or a double those
real numbers I described earlier and
then percent Li for a long integer so
here's the first example of like
inconsistencies in an ideal world it
would just be percent L and we'd move on
it's percent Li instead in this case
that's printf and some of its format
codes what more might we do well in C as
we'll see no pun intended there's a
whole bunch of operators and indeed
computers one of the first things they
did was a lot of math and calculations
so there's a lot of operators like these
computers and in turn C really good at
addition subtraction multiplication
division and even the percent sign which
is the remainder operator there's a
special symbol in C and other languages
just for getting the remainder when you
divide one number by another
there are other features in the world of
C like variables as we've seen and
there's also what is sort of playfully
called syntactic sugar that makes it
easier over time to write fewer
characters but express your thoughts the
same so just as a single example of this
as a single example consider this
use of a variable last week here in
scratch is how you might set a variable
called counter to zero in C it's going
to be similar if you want the variable
to be called counter you literally write
the word counter or whatever you want it
to be called you then use the assignment
operator AKA you Google sign and you
assign it whatever its initial value
should be here on the right so again the
zero is going to get copied from right
to left into the variable because of
that single equal sign but this isn't
sufficient in C
what else is missing on the right hand
side instinctively now even if you've
never programmed in this before yeah in
front
a semicolon at the end and one other
thing I think is probably miss sing
again
a data type so what would you if we can
uh keep going back and forth here what
data type seems appropriate intuitively
for a counter
int for integer so indeed we need to
tell the computer when creating a
variable what type of data we want and
we need to finish our thought with the
semicolon so there might be a
counterpart there what about inscribe if
we wanted to increment that counter
variable we had this very user friendly
puzzle piece last time that was change
counter by one or add one to counter in
C here's where things get a little more
interesting
and pretty commonly done you might do
this counter equals counter plus one
with a semicolon and this is where again
it's important to note the equal sign
it's not equality otherwise this makes
no sense counter cannot equal counter
plus one right like that just doesn't
work if we're talking about integers
here that's because the equal sign is
assignment so it can certainly be the
case that you calculate counter plus one
whatever that is then you update the
value of counter from right to left to
be that new value this as we'll see is a
very common thing to do in programming
just to kind of count upward for
whatever reason you can write this more
succinctly this code here is what we'll
call syntactic Sugar sort of a fancy way
of saying the same thing with fewer
words or fewer characters on the screen
this also adds one or whatever number
you type over here to the variable on
the left and there's one other form of
syntactic sugar we're going to start
seeing too and it's even more terse than
this that too will increment counter by
one by literally changing its value by
one or if you change it to minus minus
subtracting one from it you can't do
that with two and three and four but you
can do it by default with just plus plus
or minus minus adding or subtracting one
ah so when you are changing a variable
that already has been created as we did
with the code that looks like this you
no longer need to remind the computer
what the data type is thankfully the
computers uh at least as smart as that
it will remember the type of the data
that you intended
other questions or comments on this
all right that's quite a lot why don't
we go ahead and here take a 10 minute
break and we'll be back we'll start
writing some code
all right
so we are back we've just looked at some
of the basics of compiling even if it
doesn't quite feel that basic but now
let's actually start focusing really on
writing more and more code more and more
interesting code kind of like we dove
into scratch uh last week so here I have
vs code open I've closed the GUI I'm
going to focus more on my terminal
window and my code editors many
different ways I can create new files
but I want to create something called a
calculator so again within this
environment of vs code I can literally
write the code command which is vs code
specific and it just creates a new file
for me automatically or I could do that
in the GUI I'm going to go ahead and
create this file called calculator.c and
I'm going to go ahead and include some
familiar things so I'm just going to go
ahead and proactively include cs50.h
standardio.h I'm going to go ahead from
memory and do the in void main more on
that next week why it's in why it's void
and so forth and now let me just
Implement a very simple calculator we
saw like some mathematical operators
like Plus and the like so let's actually
use this so let me go ahead and first
give myself a variable called X sort of
like grade school math or algebra let me
go ahead then and get an INT which is
new but I mentioned this exists and then
let me just ask the user for whatever
their x value is the thing in the quotes
is just the English or the string that
I'm printing on the screen so I could
say anything I want I'm just going to
say x colon to prompt the user
accordingly now I'm going to go ahead
and get another variable called y I'm
going to get int again and now I'm going
to prompt the user for y and I'm just
very nitpically losing a space just to
like move the cursor so it doesn't look
too messy on the screen and then lastly
let me go ahead and just print out the
sum of X and Y in an Ideal World I would
just say something like print F X Plus y
but that is not valid in C the first
argument recall in printf has to be a
string in double quotes So if I want to
print out the value of an integer I need
to put put something in quotes here may
be followed by a new line if I want to
move the cursor as well so again we only
glimpsed it briefly but what do I
replace these question marks with if I
want a placeholder for an integer
yeah so percent I right just like
percent s with string percent I is
integer so I change this percent I and
now if I want to add X and Y for
instance super simple calculator doesn't
do much of anything other than addition
of two integers I think this works and
again it looks definitely cryptic at
first glance like it would be nice if
programming weren't this cryptic other
languages will clean this up for us but
again if you focus on the basics printf
takes one input first which is a format
string with English or whatever language
some placeholders maybe then it takes
potentially more arguments after the
comma like the value of x plus y all
right let me go ahead now and make
calculator which again compiles my
source code in C pictured above and
converts it into corresponding machine
code or zeros and ones no error messages
so that's that's already good now I do
dot slash calculator let's do one plus
one and enter voila now I have the
makings of account calculator
now let's start to Tinker with this a
little bit what if I instead had done
this int Z gets X Plus Y and then plug
in Z here
if I rerun make calculator enter rerun
dot slash calculator type in one plus
one still equals two and let me claim
that it will work for other values as
well
which of these versions is better
designed if both seem to be correct at
very cursory glance is this version
better or is the previous one without
the Z
okay so this one's arguably better
because I've now got a reusable variable
called Z that I can not only print but
Heck if my program is longer I can use
it elsewhere counter thoughts
yeah debatable like before because it
depends on my intent and honestly I
think a pretty good argument could be
made for the first version because if I
have no intention of as you note using
that letter uh that variable again you
know what maybe I might as well do this
just because it's one less thing to
think about it's one less distraction
it's one less line of code to have to
understand it's just a little tighter so
here again I think it does depend on
your intention but this feels pretty
reasonable and I think as someone noted
earlier when I did the same thing with
get string that yeah maybe kind of cross
the line because get string and the
what's your name inside of it was just
so much longer but X Plus Y and it's not
that hard to wrap our mind around what's
going on inside of the printf argument
so again these are the kinds of thoughts
that hopefully you'll acquire the
Instinct for not necessarily reaching
the same answer as someone else but
again the thought process is what
matters here all right so how might I
enhance this program a little bit let's
just talk about style for just a moment
so X and Y at least in this case are
pretty reasonable variable names why
because like that's the go-to variable
names in math when you're adding two
things together so X and Y seem pretty
reasonable I could have done something
like well maybe my first variable should
be called first number and my next
variable should be called second number
and then down here I would have to
change this to first number plus second
number like this isn't really adding
anything semantically to help my
comprehension but that would be one
other direction we could have taken
things so if you have very simple ideas
that are conventionally expressed with
common variable names like X and Y
totally fine here what if I want to
annotate this program and remind myself
what it is it does well I can add in C
what are called comments with a slash
slash to forward slashes you can write a
note to yourself like prompt user for x
and then down here I could do something
like prompt user for y just to remind
myself what I'm doing there and down
here perform addition now in this case
not sure these comments are really
adding all that much because in the time
it took me to write and eventually read
these comments I could have just read
the three lines of code but as our
programs get more sophisticated and you
start to learn more syntax that honestly
you might forget the next day the next
week the next month might be useful to
have these sort of notes to self that
remind you of what your code is doing or
maybe even how it is doing that thing
with these early programs not really
necessary doesn't really add all that
much to our comprehension but it is a
mechanism you have in place that can
help you actually remind yourself or
remind someone else what it is that's
going on well let me go ahead and rerun
this again in this current version make
calculator and here too you might think
I'm typing Crazy Fast not really I'm
hitting tab a lot so it turns out that
Linux the operating system we're using
here in the cloud but actually Windows
and Mac OS nowadays support this too
supports autocomplete so if you only
have one program that starts with c a Al
you don't have to finish writing
calculator you can just hit Tab and the
computer will finish your thought for
you the other thing you can do is if you
hit up and keep going up you'll scroll
through your entire history of commands
so there too I've been saving some
keystrokes by hitting up quickly rather
than retyping the same darn thing again
and again so again just another little
convenience to make programming and
interacting with a command line
interface even faster all right let me
go ahead and just make sure it's
compiled in the current form the
comments have no functional impact these
green things are just notes to self let
me run calculator with maybe how about
this instead of one plus one how about
1 billion
uh oops
one million one billion and another one
billion
and that answer is 2 billion all right
so that seems correct let's run this
program one more time how about two
billion plus another 2 billion
did you know that
so apparently it's not so correct and
clearly running one plus one was not the
most robust testing of my code here what
might have gone wrong
what might have gone wrong yeah
yeah the computer probably ran out of
space with bits so it turns out with
these data types we've been talking
about string and int and also float and
Char and those other things they all use
a specific and most importantly finite
number of bits to represent them it can
vary by computer newer computers use
more bits older computers tended to use
fewer bits it's not necessarily
standardized for all of these data types
but in this case in this environment it
is using 32 bits for an integer that's a
lot with 32 bits You Can Count pretty
high this is 64 light bulbs on the stage
and could count even higher and int is
only using half of these or we have two
integers here on the stage now if you
think back to last week we talked about
eight bits at one point and if you have
eight bits eight zeros and ones you can
count as high as
256 just a good number to generally
remember is trivia eight bits gives you
256 permutations of zeros and ones 32
gives you roughly how many if anyone
knows
2 to the 32 power
so it's roughly 4 billion 2 to the 32.
if you don't know that it's it's fine
most uh programmers though eventually
remember these kinds of heuristics so
it's roughly 4 billion so that feels
like enough 2 billion plus two billion
is exactly 4 billion and that actually
should fit in a 32-bit integer the catch
is that my Mac your PC and the like also
like to support negative numbers and if
you want to support both positive and
negative numbers that technically means
with 32-bit integers you can count as
high as roughly 2 billion positive or 2
billion negative in the other direction
that's still 4 billion give or take but
it's only half as many in One Direction
or the other so how could I go about
implementing a correct calculator here
what might the solution be
yeah so not just Li which was for long
integer I have to make one more change
which is to the data type itself so let
me go back up here and change X from an
INT to a long AKA long integer and then
let me change y as well and then let me
change the format code per the little
cheat sheet we had up a few minutes ago
to Li let me recompile the calculator
seems to work okay let's rerun it now
let's do one plus one that should
obviously be the same now let's do two
billion and another 2 billion and cross
our fingers this time now we're counting
as high as 4 billion and we can go way
higher than 4 billion but we're only
kicking the can down the street a bit
even though we're now using with a long
64 bits which is as long as this stage
now that's still a finite value it might
be a really big value but it's still
finite and we'll come back at the end of
today to these kinds of fundamental
limitations because arguably now my
calculator is correct for like millions
billions of possible inputs but not all
and that's problematic if you actually
want to use my calculator for any
possible
inputs not just ones that are roughly
less than say 2 billion as in this case
are any questions then on that but it's
really just a precursor for all the
problems that we're going to have to
eventually deal with later on
a good question yes if we were still
using Z we would also have to change it
to a long otherwise we'd be ignoring 32
of the bits that had been added together
via the Longs good question
all right so how about we spice things
up with maybe not just addition here how
about
um
something with some conditions let's
start to ask some actual questions so a
moment ago recall that we had
recall that we had just the Declaration
of variables now let's look back at
something in scratch that looked a
little something like this a bunch of
puzzle pieces asking questions by way of
these conditionals and then these
Boolean Expressions here in green maybe
saying something like X is less than y
in C this actually Maps pretty cleanly
it's much cleaner from left to right
than it was with printf and join here we
have just code that looks like this if a
space two parentheses and then X less
than y and then we have something like
printf there in the middle so here it's
actually kind of a nice mapping notice
that just as the yellow puzzle piece in
scratch is kind of hugging the purple
puzzle piece that's effectively the role
that these curly braces are playing
they're sort of encapsulating all of the
code on the inside
the parentheses represent the Boolean
expression that needs to be asked and
answered to decide whether or not to do
this thing and here's an exception to
what I alluded to earlier usually when
you see a word and then a parenthesis
something and then close parenthesis I
claim that's usually a function and I'm
still feel pretty good about that claim
but there are exceptions and the word if
is not a function it's just a
programming construct it's a feature of
the C language that similarly uses
parentheses just for different purposes
for a Boolean expression how about
something like this last week if you
wanted to may have a two-way fork in the
road go this way or that way you can
have if and else in C that would look a
little something like this and if we add
in the printfs it now looks quite like
the same but it adds of course the word
else and then a couple of more curly
braces as an aside in C it's not
strictly necessary to have curly braces
if you have only one line of code
indented under beneath for best practice
though do so anyway because it makes
super clear to you and ultimately anyone
else reading your code that you intend
for just that one or more line of code
to execute how about this from last week
here was a three-way fork in the road if
x is less than y else if x is greater
than or equal to a greater than y else
if x equals y now here's where you have
some disparities between scratch and C
scratch uses an equal sign for equality
to compare two values C uses a single
equal sign for assignment from right to
left minor difference between the two
worlds in C we could implement the same
code like this the addition being just
this additional else if and if we add in
the printfs it looks a little something
now like this
this is correct both in the scratch
world and in the sea world but could
someone make a claim that this is not
again well designed exactly we don't
need the last if we need the else at
least but we don't need the at last if
because at least in the world of
comparing integers it's either going to
be less than greater than or equal to
there is no other case so you can save
you know a few seconds if you will if
your program running a blink of the eye
by only asking two questions and then
inferring what the answer to the third
must be just by nature of your own human
logic here now why is that a good thing
if for instance X and Y happen to equal
each other I type in 1 and 1 for both
values either in scratch or in the C
world in the case of this version you're
sort of stupidly asking three questions
all of which are going to get asked even
though the answer is no no yes that is
true false false true that seems to be
unnecessary because if we instead
optimize this code get rid of the
unnecessary if and just do as you
propose logically else print that X is
equal to Y now if x and D equals y
because they're both 1 or some other
value now you're only going to ask two
questions so two-thirds as many
questions and then you're going to get
your same correct result so again A
Minor Detail but again the kinds of
things you should be thinking about not
only as you write your code to be
correct but also write it to be well
designed as well all right so why don't
we go ahead and translate this into the
context of an actual program here I'll
create a blank window here and let's do
something with like points like points
on my own very first cs50 problem set
let me go ahead and run code of points.c
that's just going to give me a new text
file and then up here I'm going to do my
usual include cs50.h include
standardio.h int main void so a lot of
boilerplate so to speak in these early
programs and now let me just let's see
let's ask the user how many points did
they lose on their most recent cs50p
sets to sort of evoke my photograph of
my own very first preset last week where
I lost a couple of points myself so int
points equals get int then I'll ask a
question in English like how many points
did you lose question mark space
and then once I have this answer let's
now ask some questions of it so if
points is less than 2 borrowing the
syntax syntax that we saw on the screen
a moment ago let's go ahead and print
out something explanatory like you lost
fewer points than me backslash n all
right else if points greater than 2
which is again how many I lost I'm going
to go ahead and print out you lost more
points than me backslash n
else if wait a minute else seems to be
sufficient logically here I'm just going
to go ahead and print out something like
uh you lost the same number of points as
me backslash n so really just a
straightforward application of those
that simple idea but to like a concrete
scenario here so let me go ahead and
save this let me go ahead and run make
points enter no errors that's good run
points and then how many points did you
lose how about it's one point
all right you lost fewer points than me
how about zero points even better how
about three points and so forth so again
we have the ability to express in C now
pretty basic idea from last week in
reality which is this notion of
conditionals and asking questions
there's something subtle here though
that's maybe not super well designed
that someone might call a magic number
this is sort of programming speak for
something I've done here there's a bit
of redundancy unrelated to the if and
the else if and the else
but is there something I typed twice
just to ask perhaps for the obvious
exactly I've hard-coded so to speak
manually typed out the number two in two
locations in this case that did not come
from the user so this is apparently once
I compile this this is it you're always
comparing yourself to me in like 1996
which For Better or For Worse is all the
program can do but this is an example
two of a magic number in the sense like
wait where did that two come from and
why is it in two places it feels like we
are setting the stage for just a higher
probability of screwing up down the road
because the longer this code gets
suppose I'm comparing against two points
elsewhere two three four five places am
I going to keep typing the number two
like yeah that's fine it's correct it's
going to work but honestly eventually
you're going to screw up and you're
going to miss one of the twos you're
going to change it to a three because
maybe I did worse the next year or one I
did better and you don't want these
numbers to get out of sync so what would
be like a logical Improvement to this
design rather than hard coding the same
number sort of magically in two or more
places
yeah why don't I make a variable that I
can use in there so for instance I could
create a variable like this another
integer called mine and I'm just going
to initialize it to 2 and then I'm going
to change mentions of 2 to this and mine
is a pretty reasonable name for a
variable and so far as it refers to
exactly whose points are in question
there's a risk here though minor though
it is I could accidentally change mine
at some point maybe I forget what mine
represents and I do some addition or
subtraction so there's a way to tell the
computer don't trust me because I'm
going to screw up eventually by making a
variable constant 2. so a constant in a
programming language this did not exist
in scratch is just an additional hint to
the computer that essentially enables
you to program more defensively if you
don't trust yourself necessarily to not
screw up later or honestly in practice
if you know that number should never
change make it constant and never think
about it again this tells the compiler
to make sure that even you later in your
code cannot change the number two and
another convention in C and other
languages when you have a constant it's
often common to just capitalize the
variable kind of like you're yelling but
it really just visually makes it stand
out so it's kind of like a nice rule of
thumb that helps you realize oh that
must be a constant capitalization alone
does not make it constant the word const
does but the capitalization is just a
visual reminder that this is somewhere
somehow a constant
so just a minor refinement but again
we're sort of getting better at
programming just by sort of instilling
these kinds of heuristics questions then
on conditionals
and see or these constants yeah
yeah why do you not use a semicolon and
like not lines nine thirteen no good
like just because like this is the way
the language was designed and it's
confusing early on generally speaking
when you're using conditionals and
eventually we'll see Loops there's no
semicolons involved for now assume that
semicolons usually finish your thought
after a function that's not a hundred
percent reliable of a heuristic but
it'll get you most of the way there
and just because left hand was not
talking to right hand when some of these
languages were designed
all right so let's do something else how
about this if I have the ability to ask
something conditionally is this thing
true or is this other thing could I
write a very simple program that does
something basic like tells me if a
number of the human types is even or odd
well let me just get the framework for
that in place let me go ahead and write
code of a parity is a fancy way of
saying even or odd and let me go ahead
and include cs50.h
include standardio.h int main void again
more on those down the road but for now
I'm going to go ahead and get a number n
from the user by calling get int and
asking them for whatever n is and then
now I'm going to introduce some pseudo
code so here's the first example of a
program honestly that I'm not really
sure how to proceed so let me just
resort to some pseudo code using
comments eventually I'll get rid of this
and write actual code but if n is even
then
print actually let me just print that
let me just go ahead and say printf
quote unquote even because I know how to
use printf else
all right I know how to print F odd so
let me just say printf quote unquote odd
so here I've sort of taken a bite out of
the problem if you will and let me go
ahead and put in my little placeholders
I want to do some kind of condition so
if question marks now let me go ahead
and fill in the blanks here else I'll
put this here so I think I'm okay now
I'm getting closer to solving this but I
still have this question mark here
how using syntax we've seen might I
determine if n is even or odd what do
you think
nice there's this little operator we I
mentioned by name earlier the remainder
operator that will let you do exactly
that if you divide any number by two
that mathematical heuristic is going to
tell you if it's even or odd based on
whether there's a remainder of 0 or 1
and that's nice because the alternative
would seem to be doing something stupid
like if n equals equals zero or n equals
equals if n equals 2 or n equals 4 and
right you would your code would be
infinitely long if you had to ask all
possible questions but if I do n uh
divided by 2
and look at the remainder
it's a little cryptic but this will
indeed do the trick so the percent sign
is the remainder operator it does
numerator divided by denominator and
returns not the result of that but
rather the remainder of that so if you
divide anything by 2 it's going to be a
zero or one remainder and if indeed 2
divides into n evenly giving you zero
then you're going to print even else
it's got to be odd but there is
something odd pun intended in this
highlighted line
what is another new piece of syntax
apparently besides the percent sign
what's a little off there yeah
yeah so that's not a typo and I even
caught myself verbally saying it a
moment ago just because it's so
ingrained what must this mean here
yeah
yeah if something's equivalent to the
other so now this is the equality
operator it's not assignment from right
to left and this one too is an example
of like literally humans not really
planning ahead perhaps left hand not
talking to right hand and that someone
decided let's use the equal sign for
assignment and then some number of
minutes or days later people are like
damn how do we now compare for equality
well let's just use two and if you think
this is a little weird in some languages
like JavaScript there's a third version
where you use three equal signs so again
it's humans that design these languages
so if you're ever frustrated by them
confused by them admittedly it might
just not have been the best design but
we just kind of have to live with it
ever since so let me go ahead and zoom
out here let me go ahead and make parity
here so make parity and again parody is
just the name of my file parity.c dot
slash parity type in a number like two
that's indeed even four that's indeed
even three that's indeed odd and so
forth if we continue testing presumably
we'll get the same kinds of answers how
about something else let me go ahead now
and let me start copying and pasting
some of this code because admittedly
it's getting a little tedious to keep
typing out all of that boilerplate at
the top let me create a program called
agree dot C that's reminiscent of like
any of those forms you have to agree to
online with a check box or typing in yes
or no or the like so let me throw away
all the guts of this main program and
now ask something like this let me go
ahead and prompt user to agree to
something I'm going to go ahead and say
about get string do you agree whatever
the question might be and I want the
human to type y or no at y or n for yes
or no respectively so if it's only a
single character actually I can actually
get by with just get Char not used it
before but it was on our menu of
functions from the cs50 library and if I
want to get the user's response the
return value should be a Char also on
the left so now we've seen strings ins
and now chars if we only care about a
single letter and now let's go ahead
whether check whether user agreed so how
about if C equals equals quote unquote y
then let me go ahead and inside of my
curly braces print out agreed or some
such sentence like that
else if they did not type c or you know
what let's be explicit here just so they
can't type Z or B or some random letter
else if C equals equals quote unquote n
for no then let me go ahead and print
out not agreed or something like that
and I'm just going to ignore the user if
they don't cooperate in the type Z or B
or something that's not y or n all right
let me go ahead now and compile this
code make agree
dot slash agree all right do I agree yes
let's go with the default okay so that
seems to work no I don't agree this time
that seems to work how about my caps
lock key is on or I'm just uh really
yelling capital Y
it ignores me capital n
it ignores me
so obviously a bug at least if I want to
tolerate uppercase and lowercase which
is kind of reasonable
so what would be the possible solutions
here do you think
how do I solve this and tolerate both up
capital and lowercase maybe what's the
simplest most naive implementation
yeah so why not just ask two questions
or you know what even more simplistic
based only on what we've seen before let
me if you will let me just kind of copy
and paste some of this code change this
to an else whoops not in cops else if
quote unquote capital Y and then I bet I
could do the same thing with n but here
too just like with scratch as soon as
you start to find yourself copy pasting
you're probably doing something wrong
and what you said verbally if I may was
actually better because you're implying
that I could just say something like or
C equals equals capital y or down here C
equals equals capital N the catch is you
can't use the word or in C it's actually
two vertical bars so you can express one
question or another you only won't need
one of the answers to be yes or true and
you use two vertical Bars by contrast
just so you've seen it if you wanted to
check if something is equal to something
and something else you could use two
ampersands this logically would make no
sense here though certainly what the
human types can't both be lowercase and
uppercase that just makes no sense so in
this case we do want or but that allows
me to tighten my code up I don't have to
start copying and pasting whole branches
I can now ask two questions at once
questions then on this variation
really good question can you convert the
input to all lowercase absolutely you
could we don't have the capability yet
it turns out that's going to require to
be easy another library that we could do
it ourselves knowing a little bit about
ASCII or Unicode from last week but yes
that would be an alternative but more on
that a different time
other questions
good question unfortunately you have to
be explicit in C you can't just say this
even though that's kind of how you might
think about it you have to ask a
complete question using the equality
sign twice in this case let me ask a
question now too it's not a typo I
deliberately used single quotes around
all of my single letters here why might
that be previously we used double quotes
for anything that looked like text
yeah
correct string is double quotes for
multiple characters or even one
technically but yes and single quotes
for
for single characters because my data
type is different I chose the simple
route of just using a single Char in
fact this program won't work with y e s
or n o That's not supported at the
moment more on that another time I had
to use single quotes because that's how
C does it if you're dealing with single
characters AKA chars use single quotes
if it's a string even if it's one single
character in a string as though you're
starting to write out a longer word or
sentence that would be double quotes and
we'll see why this is before long too
but again just sort of things to keep in
mind whenever writing code in this
particular language
yeah down here
so short answer if I'm understanding
correctly even this would be incorrect
and this would be even more incorrect
but if you don't mind let me Kick the
Can a couple of weeks on this as to why
this doesn't work the right the most
Pleasant way to do this would indeed be
to do something like this but even this
is a slippery slope because what if the
user does something weird like they
capitalize just the Y you can imagine
this getting messy quickly I like your
idea earlier about just forcing
everything to lowercase just to
standardize things unfortunately you
cannot compare strings for equality like
this for again reasons will come to
before long so for today we're keeping
it simple even though arguably it's not
nearly as user friendly to only tolerate
individual letters and there's a
question over here
uh they are on a U.S English keyboard
it's shift and then the backslash key
above return but depending on your
keyboard it will vary
all right so let's actually now uh look
back at something we did a little bit of
last week let me go ahead and open a
file called meow.c because recall that's
what we had scratch do initially let me
include not the cs50 library this time
but just standardio.h because I only
want printf for this demo let me go
ahead now and just print out meow
and then if I want the cat to meow three
times like it did last week meow meow
meow save it make meow dot slash meow
voila program is written correct I claim
it ran it compiled okay but again this
was the beginning of our conversation
last week of not being particularly well
designed and if someone wants to maybe
point out the now obvious like why is
this not well designed necessarily
yeah it's just repetition right again I
literally resorted to copy paste like
that should be the signal that you're
probably doing something uh wrong or at
best just lazy of you in this case so
the solution is you might glean from
last week is probably going to be one of
those things called Loops so let's just
take a look at some of the Syntax for
loops and see but again no new ideas
it's just some new syntax that'll take
some getting used to in scratch if you
wanted to meow forever with something
like this there's not a forever keyword
in C so this one's a little weird to
look at but this is the best we can do
it turns out there is a keyword called
while in C and that kind of has the
right command semantics because it's
like while like do something again and
again that's the best I can do
but just like in if condition or an else
if condition those took a Boolean
expression in parentheses a while loop
also takes a Boolean expression in
parentheses so I have to ask a question
now if I want to do something forever I
could kind of stupidly just say while 2
is greater than one while three is
greater than 2 or just something
completely arbitrary but that should rub
you it the wrong way because like Y2
versus one why three like just if you
want true just say true so it turns out
in C there are special keywords true and
false that are literally true and false
respectively I could also put the number
one for true and the number zero for
false but most people would just say
true to be explicit so it's a little
hackish if you will but very
conventional there's no forever keyword
in C if I want to then print meow
forever I'm going to just use something
like printf here so again not a perfect
translation from one to the other but
absolutely possible able in C what about
this this is a little more common if you
want to do something a finite number of
times like repeat three
there's a few different ways we can do
this in C
here's one I would approach and here's
where C like a lot of text-based
languages you kind of have to whip out
that toolkit of all the basic building
blocks and think about all right how can
I build a little machine in software
that does something some number of times
well let me give myself a variable
called counter set it equal to zero let
me create a loop whose Boolean
expression is is counter less than three
the idea being here why don't I just
kind of count one two three so how do I
implement this physicality in code I
give myself a variable set it to zero
zero fingers up now I ask the question
is counter less than three if so go
ahead and print out meow and just
intuitively even if you've never seen C
code or any code before scratch what
more do I need to do I've left a room
here for one more line of logic
yeah
we have to increase counter so I need
code like I showed earlier like counter
equals counter plus one and so here's
where like programming sometimes becomes
a bit more like Plumbing like you can't
just say what you mean like you could in
scratch you have to build a little sort
of software machine that initializes
value does something increments it
checks it and so it's kind of like this
software-based machine but together
that's just using some familiar building
blocks but this is pretty common just
like in scratch you might have used
Loops a bunch of times pretty common in
C so can we tighten this code up this is
correct but here are some new here's
some conventions that are popular
you don't if you're going to count just
say I a convention in programming with
at least languages like C is just use I
as an integer if all its purpose is is
to count from like zero on up counter is
not wrong it's not bad it's just uh like
it's more verbose than you need to be
just call it I you don't need more
semantics than that all right what else
can I do here there's another
opportunity to tighten up this code do
you recall yeah
yeah that syntactic sugar that does
nothing new but it does it more
succinctly I can change this to either
the intermediate format or the even a
tighter format of just I plus plus now
this is pretty canonical like this is
how many people most people would
Implement something three times using a
loop in C using a while loop that is
turns out that it's so common in C and
other languages to do something finitely
many times there's a couple of ways to
do it in this model to be clear the
logic though is that we start by
initializing the variable like I've
highlighted here we then ask the
question is I less than zero if so
everything that's indented inside the
curly braces gets executed namely meow
then the update then the computer is
going to recheck the condition to make
sure that I hasn't gotten so big that
it's greater than three but if not it
then does this again and it does this
again and then it repeats constantly
checking the condition and executing
what's in the block checking the
condition and executing what's in the
block after three times of that the
condition is going to be false or a no
answer and that's it for the code it
just proceeds to whatever's down here
just like with scratch it jumps to the
next blocks down below
all right what's another way though to
do this well I've deliberately been
counting from zero and that's a
programming convention right we started
last week with all the light bulbs off
which was zero so it's pretty reasonable
to start counting at zeros just like you
would here like no fingers are up this
is zero fingers on your hand but if you
prefer you could start counting at I
equals one but then you don't want to do
it while I is less than three you want
to do I is less than or equal to three
on most keyboards there's no symbol for
less than or equal to or greater than or
equal to so in C you use two characters
less than and then an equal sign with no
spaces in between that just means less
than or equal to we could change it to
set I to two and make this condition be
less than or equal to four we could make
this be
10 and less than or equal to 12 but
again just stick with the basics start
at zero and count on up would be the
convention or if you prefer to count
down that's fine too said eyed is three
and then do this so long as I is greater
than zero but you have to decrement
instead of increments so again we could
do this all day long there's like
literally an infinite number of ways to
implement this idea and that's why I
keep emphasizing convention call the
variable I for something like this
initialize it to zero for something like
this and just generally count up unless
you really prefer to count down again
just certain human conventions all right
how about another way to do this this is
what's called a for Loop in C also very
common it's not quite as straightforward
in that it doesn't really read top to
bottom in the exactly the same way this
kind of has a lot more logic tucked into
its first line but it does exactly the
same thing what happens here is notice
that inside the parentheses next to the
word four there's two semicolons which
is another weird use of syntax they're
not at the end of the line now they're
in the middle of the parentheses but
that's what the humans chose years ago
the first thing before the semicolons
initial realizes your variable int I
equals zero the next thing is the
condition that's going to constantly get
checked every cycle through this Loop
and the last thing is going to be what
you do after each Loop which in this
case is going to be count up so again if
I rewind we initialize I to zero we then
ask the question is I Less Than 3 if so
execute what's inside of the loop
then the computer asks does this it does
the update incrementing I by 1
and then it's not going to blindly meow
again it's going to check again the
condition is I less than three then it's
going to meow if so then it might go
ahead and increment I and check the
condition again so again this does not
read quite in the same simple Fashion
top to bottom you kind of read it left
to right and then jump around but again
the initialization
the constant Boolean expression being
checked and the update after each time
does the exact same thing as what we saw
a moment ago in this while loop
formats which one is better and they're
the same I think most people would
probably eventually use a for Loop once
comfortable but just because is really
the answer there
all right any questions then on Loops as
we've translated them to see yeah
uh for Loop and while loop can both be
used to do exactly the same thing there
are subtle differences with issues of
scope which we'll discuss before long
where when you create a variable in a
for Loop notice that it was again inside
of those parentheses which technically
means it's only going to exist in these
four lines of Code by contrast with the
while loop I declared my variable
outside of the loop that variable is
going to continue it to Exist Elsewhere
in my program so that's one of the minor
differences there
good question but you'll see some others
over time all right so we claim then
that it's better in some form to do this
with loops so let's actually jump back
to the code let me go ahead and now
re-implement meowing with a for Loop for
instance so how about four into I get
zero I less than three whoops I less
than three I plus plus then inside my
curly braces let me go ahead and print
out with printf meow with a new line and
a semicolon so I did it pretty quickly
just because I long acquired the muscle
memory but if I now make meow no errors
there run dot slash meow and I see meow
meow meow well let's do now what we did
last week which was to begin to make our
own custom functions if you will by
using our own in C so here's where the
syntax gets a little funky but we'll
explain over time why what each of these
keywords is doing if I want to create a
function called meow because the authors
of C did not create a function called
meow decades ago I need to give it a
name like meow I need to specify if it
takes any inputs for now I'm going to
say no
and I'm going to explicitly Say No by
writing this special word void
it's also necessary when implementing a
function in C which was not necessary in
scratch to specify what its return type
is but for now I'm just going to say
that meow is the name of the function it
takes no inputs and that's what the void
in parentheses means and it does not
return anything like get uh like ask did
or like get string or get intuz meow's
purpose in life is just to have side
effects visual Side Effects by printing
something on the screen
so what is meow gonna do I'm gonna have
it quite simply say printf quote unquote
uh meow backslash n and now just like in
scratch I can now just call a brand new
function called meow and here's where
too if you really don't like the curly
braces technically speaking you can get
rid of them when there's only one line
of code inside your Loop but again
stylistically I would encourage you to
preserve them to make super clear to
yourself and others what it is that's
going on let me go ahead and save this
and do make meow whoops
darn all right what did I do something
stupid
yeah so zero does not belong there I
meant to hit parenthesis parenthesis so
let me rerun make meow okay fixed my
mistake all right it's still working
okay but recall what I did in scratch
kind of out of sight out of mind and
just to make a point let me just kind of
highlight this and move it way down in
the file because again like now that
meow exists it's an abstraction I just
know a meow function exists I want to be
able to use it so let me scroll back up
my main function is the same let me go
ahead and make meow again
and now just by moving that function
I've created all these lines of errors
and let's look at the first again the
rule of thumb here it's a little small
but it says meow.c in bold which is the
name of the file where the bug is 5 is
the line number and 20 is the character
so line numbers and no enough alone uh
let's see
oh this is what happens when I scrolled
up too far sorry this is the error we're
now looking at line seven I was looking
at the old error message from earlier
before I fixed the zero meow see line
seven all right apparently C does not
know what the meow function is implicit
declaration a function meow is invalid
in c99 well what does that mean
Declaration of function means your
creation of a function like I'm
declaring that meow exists but I haven't
apparently defined it yet and then c99
is the version of C from the year 1999
which we generally use here it's one of
the more recent versions
so why is that the case
can you infer from the mere fact that I
just moved me out to the bottom of the
file which was fine in scratch but now
is bad why is that
yeah C is just kind of old school it
reads your code top to bottom and if it
does not know what meow is when you
first try to use it it just freaks out
and prints out these error messages so
the solution is quite simply don't do
that just leave it where it was but you
could imagine this getting a little
Annoying over time if only because main
is by name the main part of your program
and honestly it would just be nice
honestly if Maine were always at the top
of your code because if you want to
understand what a file is doing it makes
sense you just read it top to bottom
well there is a solution to this you can
put functions in different orders with
main at the top so long as you and this
is perhaps the only time copy paste is
appropriate so long as you leave a
little breadcrumb for the compiler at
the very top of your file that literally
repeats the return value the name and
the arguments to that function semicolon
this is so to speak declaring your
function and the real fancy way is this
is a prototype it's like what is this
thing going to look like but the
semicolon means I'm not going to deal
with this yet I'm going to actually
Define the function or implement it down
below here this is kind of a stupid
detail more recent languages get away
get rid of this need you can put your
functions in any order but again if you
just think about the basics of
programming languages like this one here
and as you noted it must just be reading
your code top to bottom so annoying yes
but explained yes too so let me go ahead
and make meow once more time dot slash
meow still working okay and let me make
one final enhancement to this meow
program here let me go ahead now and say
something like this let me go ahead and
say all right wouldn't it be nice ice if
my meow function could do something for
me some number of times so suppose I
want to do this this male function at
the moment is going to meow three times
but suppose I want to meow n times where
n is just some number provided by the
user well just like in scratch custom
functions can take inputs I just
presently am saying void but if I change
this to int n thereby telling the
compiler hey meow still doesn't return
something but it does take something as
input it takes an integer and I want to
call it n so this is another way of
declaring a variable but a way of
declaring a variable that gets handed
into as input the function so now if I
tighten up main here now I can actually
do something really cool just like in
scratch which is this if I now look at
this code let me zoom in here now my
main program is really well written in
the sense that it just says what it does
meow three times this works though
because I Define meow is now taking an
input an integer called n and then using
n in my
now familiar for Loop there's one change
might have caught my one mistake I also
have to remind myself up here to make
that change too again this is one of the
only redundancies or copy paste that's
sort of reasonable
but there I have now a better version so
let me go ahead and rerun this uh make
meow dot slash meow voila so again no
change in correctness but now again
we're sort of modularizing our code and
heck what you could do now and this is
just a teaser featured down the road
those header files we talked about early
those libraries this is the kind of
modularization we're talking about we
the staff wrote a function called get
string get int and so forth we put it in
a file called cs50.c and we put little
breadcrumbs specifically these things
called prototypes in cs50.h
so that when you all as aspiring
programmers include cs50.8 you are sort
of secretly telling the compiler at the
very top of your code what the menu of
available functions is why because in
cs50.8 is lines like these obviously not
for meow but for get string get int and
so forth and in standard io.h is the
same lines of code for things like
printf so that's all that's going on
there it's just a way of telling the
computer in advance what functions to
expect
or any questions then
on these here
correct so if you don't mind I want to
continue to wave my hand at that detail
for today indeed int main void is a
little weird because like what would the
input domain be we have no mechanism for
providing input yet and what does it
mean for Maine to return anything like
who is it returning to for another day
if we may they're going to come into
play but that for now today is just
something you should take at face value
as necessary copy paste to begin
programs so meow is a function that
takes an input the number of times to
meow but it didn't actually have a
return value hence the void but what if
we actually want to create our own
function that not only takes zero or
more inputs as arguments but also
returns some value maybe an INT maybe a
float maybe something else altogether
well it turns out since C we can do that
as well let me go ahead and create a new
file here called discount and let's
Implement a quick program via which we
can discount some regular price by some
percentage as though there's a sale
going on in a store let me go ahead and
include our usual
cs50.h followed by standard i o and at
the top let me give myself in main void
as before and inside of main let's go
ahead and do something simple let's give
ourselves a float called regular
representing like the regular price of
something in a store let's go ahead and
get a float from the user asking them
what that regular price is then next
let's go ahead and declare a second
variable also a float called sale
ultimately representing the sale price
after some percentage discount off and
let's go ahead and simply calculate
whatever regular is and say 15 off is a
pretty good discount so let's go ahead
and discount regular Whatever It Is by
15 which is equivalent of course to
multiplying it with the asterisk by 0.85
of course if we're taking off 15 we
multiply the regular price by 0.85 now
let's go ahead and print out the results
here let me go ahead and say printf
sale price colon let me go ahead and use
percent F but more specifically percent
dot 2f because at least in U.S currency
we typically show cents to two decimal
places followed by a new line and then
let me go ahead and plug in the value of
sale all right let's go down here and do
make discount enter so far so good dot
slash discounts and the regular price is
maybe one hundred dollars so the sale
price should be eighty five dollars so
our arithmetic seems to be correct here
but let's fast forward now in time
suppose that we find ourselves
discounting a lot of prices in an
application maybe a website like Amazon
where they're offering some kind of
percentage discount and be nice to have
a reusable function that just does this
arithmetic for us simple though it may
be so let's go ahead and modify discount
this time to give ourselves our own
function called discount for instance
that takes an input like the regular
price that you want to Discount and then
it also returns a value it doesn't just
print it out it returns a value namely a
float that represents what the sale
price is so let let me go down below
Main and go ahead and Define a function
that's going to return a float because
we're dealing with dollar amounts still
the function is going to be called
discount and it's going to take one
input like the price that we want to
Discount in here I'm going to do
something very simple I'm going to say
float sale equals whatever that price is
times 0.85 and then I'm going to go
ahead and return sale now for that
matter I can actually tighten this up a
bit if I'm only declaring a variable to
store a value then I'm then returning
with this keyword return I actually
don't even need that variable so I can
delete the second line and I can
actually just go ahead and get rid of
that variable altogether and immediately
return whatever the arithmetic result is
of taking the price input the argument
that's being passed in times .85 so very
simple function that simply does the
discounting for me as always let me go
ahead and copy paste the almost the only
time it's okay to copy paste the
Prototype of that function to the top of
the file so that when compiling this
code code main has already seen the word
discount before and now let me go into
the code here and instead of doing the
math myself in main let me presume that
we have some function already in our
toolkit called discount that lets me
discount the regular price and return
that value and then down here my code
doesn't need to change I'm still going
to print out sale the variable in which
I'm storing that result but notice what
I've done here I've sort of abstracted
the way the notion of taking a discount
by creating my own function that takes a
float called price or anything else as
input it does a little bit of math
simple though it is here and then it
returns a value but notice that discount
is not printing that value it's
literally using this other keyword
called return so that I can hand back
that value just like get string hands
back a value just like get in hands back
and integer without printing it for you
so that I up here on line 9 can go ahead
and store that value in a variable if I
want and then actually print it out let
me go ahead head now and recompile this
code with make discount
let me go ahead and do dot slash
discount and let's again do a hundred
dollars
sale price is going to be point eighty
five dollars as well now it turns out
that functions don't have to take just
zero or one argument as input they can
actually take two or three or more so in
fact suppose we wanted to now enhance
this version of my program and take in
as input to the discount function not
just the price that I want to discount
but also the percentage off thereby
allowing us to support not just 15
percent off but any number of percentage
points off well let me go up here and
declare an insay and call it percent off
and let me ask the user for how many
percentage points they want to take off
so I'm going to say percent off inside
of the prompt here get that int call
percent off and now in addition to
passing in regular as an input to the
discount function I'm also going to pass
in percent off but I need to tell the
computer that it is taking now two
arguments and the way I do this is just
with a comma down here in the function
Zone definition here is going to be a
percentage argument a second argument
per the comma and I'm now going to use
that percentage in a slightly a familiar
way I don't want to just do percentage
like this because of course that's going
to increase the size of the total price
I actually need to do a little bit of
real world math where if this is a
percentage off like the number 15 for 15
percentage points I need to do like a
hundred minus that many percentage
points thereby giving me 100 minus 15.85
and then I need to divide that by 100 in
order now to give myself 0.85 times the
price that was passed in but if I go
ahead now and save this run make
discount one last time I notice that
I've actually got an error here what
have I done wrong well I need to change
that prototype too and again this is
admittedly an annoying aspect of C that
you have to maintain consistency here
but that's fine I'm just going to go up
here change this to int percentage
spelling incorrectly and now let me
retry compilation make discount crossing
my fingers this time worked okay a DOT
slash discount and voila 100 and percent
off say 15 points and voila 85
now it's worth noting that I've
deliberately returned the results of my
math from this function I haven't just
done the math on the original variable
that's being passed in in fact if we
take a look at this second version where
discount is now taking a price argument
and a percentage argument notice that
I'm not doing something like this I'm
not just saying price equals price times
100 minus percentage divided by 100 and
leaving it that the problem there is
that this variable price is going to be
scoped to that discount function and
we'll encounter this again before long
but this notion of scope just refers to
where in which a variable actually lives
or exists or is accessible so it turns
out if I change price in the context of
this discount function that's not going
to have a lasting effect if I actually
want to get the result back to the
function that use the discount function
namely Maine I actually do need to take
this approach of actually returning the
value explicitly so that ultimately I'm
handing back the discounted price all
right well let's go ahead and maybe how
about let's just use these Primitives in
just a few different ways how about a
little game of uh yesteryear Super Mario
Brothers and in the original Super Mario
Brothers and in bunches of variants in
so you have like these uh side-scrolling
worlds that look like this where there's
some coins in the sky hidden behind
these question marks so let's just use
this as a visual to consider how in C
could I start to make something
semi-graphical like not actual colors or
fanciness that feels like too much too
soon just something like printing out
some question marks well if I go back
over here let me create that actual file
that I alluded to earlier so let me code
up mario.c let me go ahead and include
standardio.h int main void again which
will continue to copy paste for today
and then let me just go ahead and do
something simple like one two three four
and a new line all right this is what we
might call ASCII art which just means
Graphics but really just implemented
with your keyboard and if I make Mario
and Dot slash Mario it's not nearly as
engaging visually as this but it's the
beginning of this kind of map for a game
well if I wanted to now print out of
those things dynamically let me go back
to my code here and instead of printing
out four all at once I could do
something like for INT I get 0 I less
than four I plus plus and then inside
here I could just print out one of them
at a time let me save that make Mario
and at the risk of disappointing so
close
but I made a mistake just stupid
aesthetic the The Prompt is not on the
new line how could I move it
yeah I need an escape character the
backslash n but where should I put it
here
okay no because that's going to put it
after everyone and it's going to make
this thing vertical instead of
horizontal so logically just like in
scratch put it at the end of the loop so
something out here and just print out
for instance only quote unquote new line
and now if I do make Mario again dot
slash Mario okay we're back in business
but a little better designed in that now
I'm not repeating myself multiple times
I'm doing this again and again but let's
do one other thing here with Mario let
me go ahead and ask the user how many
question marks or coins to print the
catch here is that there's another type
of loop that's helpful for this and it's
called a do while loop generally a do
while loop is similar to a while loop
but it checks the condition last instead
of first recall earlier on the slide we
had while open parenthesis close
parenthesis and I kept claiming that we
checked whether I is less than whatever
it was three in advance again and again
a do while loop just inverts the logic
so that you can actually do something
like this at the top of this program I'm
going to go ahead now and give myself a
variable n like this of type integer and
then I'm going to do literally the
following with the keyword do n equals
get int and I'm going to ask the user
for the width like the number of dollar
signs to print and I'm going to do this
while n is less than say one
so this is a little cryptic but the
Salient differences are the while the
Boolean expression is now at the bottom
of my block of code not at the top
now why is this well the difference here
if I make Mario
is whoops uh I need to add cs50.h
because I'm now using get int
if I now compile this version of Mario
and do dot slash Mario
a do while loop is helpful when you want
to do something no matter what first and
then check some condition or some
Boolean expression to see if maybe in
this case the user cooperated it would
make no sense if the user typed in say
zero because like there's no work to be
done it'd be really weird if they said
negative 100 because that makes no sense
logically so with this simple construct
here
I am doing the following while n is less
than one the implication is that as soon
as n equals one or is bigger than one
I'm going to break out of this Loop and
I've got myself a variable called n
containing essentially a positive value
one through two billion or so and I can
now use this for instance here change
the 4 to an N so now my program is
completely Dynamic let me go ahead and
do make Mario dot slash Mario again and
I'll do four still works I'll do 40.
still works and the difference here with
the do while is if something like this
involves getting user input well there's
no question to ask like the user hasn't
given you anything yet so you have to do
something first then check and break out
of the loop if the human has for
instance cooperated in this case
all right well why don't we escalate to
something more like this in the same
game where your underground is Mario and
this is like a two-dimensional uh wall
That's popping up here it looks like a
three by three for instance for the sake
of discussion and it's like made of
bricks so I'll use maybe hash symbols
this time well it turns out that we can
Nest that is combine some of these same
ideas as follows let me go ahead now
and change back to this code and I'm
going to keep the do while loop from
before and I'm going to ask though this
question what's the size of this Square
I'm going to assume it's like x n by n
so three by three four by four whatever
so I'm just going to ask for the size of
the square of bricks and now how do I do
this well I'm going to go ahead for
instance and print out about four and I
get zero I less than n i plus plus let
me just keep it simple and print out
something like this just a single hash
symbol that is a brick and a new line
after it all right let's make Mario Run
Mario of three okay that's close to
being it I've got a column all right but
I need to be wider so the solution last
time was to get rid of the new line and
then we put the new lines here out after
the loop all right so let's do make
Mario dot slash Mario and type in three
and aha all right so I kind of need to
combine these two ideas somehow so how
might we solve this problem
I want to print like rows and columns
not row or column
how do I do this yeah
yeah add another loop in the for Loop
right if you use one Loop conceptually
to kind of count the rows from top to
bottom and then within each row you then
sort of typewriter style old school
typewriter do like character character
character character horizontally I think
we could do exactly what we want to
achieve here so how about this let me
get rid of this line and get rid of this
line for now and let me just give myself
another loop on the inside and since I'm
already using I another reasonable
convention here would be to say
something like J so J also gets zero J
is less than n j plus plus and now
what's going to happen let me go ahead
and print out just one of these things
at a time
and let me save and write let me run
this let me see if it how close we are
make Mario's three okay three that's
clearly wrong but I see nine things
there on the screen so we're close
what's the one fix I need now to sort of
move the old school typewriter head down
to the next row when appropriate what do
you think
yeah I need one of these backslash ends
and probably let me add some comments
now to help everyone visualize what I've
done for each row
for each column how about print a brick
just to kind of explain the logic and so
I add that because now
move to next row I could do something
like this with a backslash n so here is
where this the comments really my pseudo
code actually kind of illuminates the
situation a bit let me go ahead and
recompile Mario dot slash Mario 3. now
we're talking it's not a perfect square
just because these hash symbols are a
little taller than they are wide but
that's just a font detail here now I've
done something that's quite more akin to
something like this
all right so let me pause here and see
if there are any questions
again the code's getting a little more
complicated but we're just building like
more complicated programs like in
scratch with like familiar puzzle pieces
some variables Some Loops some
conditionals it's all the same as before
yeah
can you multiply strings and see no uh
but ask that same question again in a
few weeks when we get to Python and the
answer will be yes
other questions yeah
in C you must specify the return type
the name of the function and the inputs
or arguments to the function in that
order and if none of them are applicable
you write the word void
uh so same question as earlier let me
kick that can a week or so and we'll
come back to that and we'll see why but
for now just take on faith that you need
to do that with Maine because Maine is a
little special similar to the when green
flag is clicked it too was a little
special as well
yes if you want to get out of a loop
early you could do this so let me answer
this question this way an alternative to
a do while loop would be to do something
like this uh
how about while true so do the following
forever let me go ahead and get an end
from the user for the size of this thing
if n is greater than zero that is a
positive integer then go ahead and use a
new keyword called break this is
identical to what we just did it's just
a little longer it's like a couple extra
lines a lot of them are blank and so
it's just an alternative but a do while
does the same thing but a little tighter
if that's an answer to your question
all right so let's now introduce finally
a sequence of problems that I've kind of
been brushing under the rug though we
did see a little bit of evidence of this
earlier when we tried to add 2 billion
and 2 billion and it overflowed the
number of bits in an inch so to speak
let me go ahead and code up a program uh
called calculator again but I'm going to
go ahead now and change us to floats so
I'm going to change X to a float and I'm
going to use get float and a float again
is just a floating point value which is
a fancy way of saying a real number with
a decimal point in it and down here I'm
going to go ahead and use percent f for
float and I'm going to go ahead now and
do one more thing instead of addition I
want to do something fancier like
division so divide X by Y and I'm going
to give myself another third float
called Z as we did at the beginning of
today and I'm going to print out Z
instead of X and Y explicitly so I'm
going to go ahead now and do make
calculator
dot slash calculator and let's do
something like oh two-thirds two divided
by three is point six six six six seven
so that's what you would rather expect
let me run it again one tenth
all right so point one and a bunch of
zeros that two is what you would rather
expect but now let me get a little
curious it turns out that in C you can
modify the behavior of these format
codes a little bit by default you get
like six or so digits suppose that you
want to get exactly two digits you can
more succinctly say 0.2 before the F and
after the percent this is the kind of
thing that's hard to remember but you
Google it and you find that okay format
code for floats uses 0.2 to do two
decimal points so let me do make
calculator again dot slash calculator
how about two-thirds point six seven so
it handles the display of significant
digits for us here and now let me go
ahead and do one-tenth and 0.10 so it's
adhering to that well maybe I really
want a lot of precision right I've got a
really powerful computer let me see 50
numbers after the decimal point that's a
lot of significant digits let me remake
the calculator whoops typo let me remake
the calculator
dot slash not Mario calculator and how
about two-thirds again
well that's interesting
pretty sure it's supposed to be like a
0.6 with like a line over it right and
in grade school math all right well
maybe that's just a bug how about one
tenth okay that's really getting funky
so what's going on it seems that my
program can not only not do addition
very well we eventually hit problems in
the billions we can't even do very
precise numbers here
what's going on
exactly in a nutshell the computer is
approximating the answer using that many
uh numbers after the decimal point but
the problem fundamentally is actually
very similar to that integer overflow
from before and I'm using that now as a
term of R integers can overflow if
you're trying to use more bits than you
actually have available to you you sort
of change them all to ones and then
you're out of bits so to speak same
thing here but in the different context
of floats if you only have 32 bits or
Heck if we change to double and only
have 64 bits that's a lot of precision
but it's not infinite and yet pretty
sure there's an infinite number of real
numbers in the world which is to say a
computer with finite memory cannot
possibly represent all possible numbers
in the world because again there's not
an infinite number of permutations of 32
or 64 bits it might be a lot in the
billions or more but it's still finite
and so indeed this is the computer's
closest approximation to what's actually
going on there and so this is an example
of what we would actually generally call
floating point in Precision floating
point in Precision refers to the
inability for computers fundamentally to
represent all possible real numbers one
hundred percent precisely at least by
default in languages like C thankfully
in the world of scientific Computing and
so forth there are solutions to this
problem that just give you more digits
but the problem fundamentally is still
going to be there so there's a reason I
changed X and Y to floats let's see what
would happen if we re-round a bit and
instead of using floats for X and Y
again you say integer so into X and int
Y and let's go far back into get int as
well thereby giving us integers X and Y
let's still leave Z as a float because
at the end of the day we want to be able
to handle fractions or floating Point
values but let's go ahead now and print
out this value of Z having changed X and
Y now to ins make calculator
dot slash calculator and let's do say 2
for the numerator 3 for the denominator
and voila it's not .66 and it's not even
rounding oddly it's just all zeros this
time so why is that well it turns out
that c when dividing an integer by an
integer is always going to give you back
an integer an INT the problem is that
floating Point values don't fit in ends
only the integral part to the left of
the decimal point does everything at and
Beyond the decimal point itself get
thrown away known as a feature in C
called truncation when dividing an
integer by an integer you get back an
integer but if you're trying to then
store it what's actually a floating
Point result in that integer C is just
going to throw away everything at and
Beyond the decimal point leaving us with
this case in just the Zero from what
should have been
0.666666 and so forth so let's see one
more example in fact let me go back to
my terminal here let me do dot slash
calculator again and let's do four
thirds this time it should be 1.3 3333
and so forth but let's see 4 divided by
3 both as integers this time gives us
1.000 but they are two the answer should
be 1.333 but the floating Point part is
getting truncated or thrown away leaving
us with just one so how do we solve this
well certainly we could just use floats
from the get-go as I did but if by
nature of your program you only have
access to integers or maybe even Longs
for which the same problem would occur
what we can actually do is called type
conversion and we can explicitly tell
the computer that we actually want to
treat this int as though it's a floating
point value and we can do that for both
X and Y so let me go back to my code
here and I have a couple of options in
fact I can convert y to a float by doing
this I can cast y to a float by
literally writing the type float inside
of parentheses right before the Y and if
I really want to be explicit I can also
do the same to X but strictly speaking
it suffices to just change one or the
other not necessarily both let me go
ahead now and do make calculator again
dot slash calculator and let's try 2
divided by three and now we're back to
an answer that's closer to correct but
indeed we're still having some rounding
issues there let's run it one more time
for 4 divided by three there too we're
closer to the right answer at least but
we still have that floating point in
Precision but that's going to be another
problem altogether to solve and here in
a little more detail is that issue of
integer overflow which is in the context
of ins suppose that we think back last
week when we had three bits and we
counted from like zero to seven zero one
two three four five six seven I think I
asked the question how would we count to
eight someone proposed well we need a
fourth bit that's fine if you have a
fourth bit if you have access to another
light bulb or transistor if you don't
though the next number after this is
technically one zero zero zero but if
you don't have space for or hardware for
that fourth bit you might as well just
be representing the number zero so in
the world of integers if you're only
using three bits those three bits
eventually overflow when you count past
seven because what should be eight can't
fit so to speak so it rolls back over to
zero and as Arcane as this problem might
seem we humans have done this a couple
of times you might recall knowing about
or reading about the Y2K problem where a
lot of people thought the world was
going to end why because does on January
1st of 2000 a lot of computers
presumably were going to update their
clocks from 1999 to the year 2000. the
problem is though for decades for
efficiency we humans were honestly in
the habit of not storing years as four
digits why because that's just a lot of
space to waste especially since like
centuries don't happen that often so a
lot of computer systems especially early
on when Hardware was very expensive and
memory was very tight just stored the
last two digits of any year problem of
course on January 1st of 2000 is that 99
rolls over to a hundred but if you don't
have room for another digit it's just
zero zero and if your code assumes a
prefix of 19 well we just went from the
year 1999 back to the year 1900
thankfully long story short a lot of
people wrote a lot of code and a lot of
old languages and mostly worded off this
problem so the world did not end the
next time the world might end though is
on January 19th 2038 right now that
might feel like a long time away but so
did the year 2000 at one point why might
clocks again break in today's modern
computers in 2038 might you think
indeed so this refers to some number of
seconds so it turns out that the way
computers generally keep track of time
is they count the total number of
seconds since the epoch which is which
is defined as January 1st 1970. why it
was just a good year to sort of start
counting at when computers really came
onto the scene unfortunately most
computers use 32 bits to count the
number of seconds since January 1st 1970
the implication of which is we can only
count up to roughly 2 billion seconds 2
billion seconds is going to happen on
2038 at which point 31 ones are going to
roll over as follows that number 2
billion which is the max because if
you're representing positive and
negative numbers recall that you can
only count as high as positive 2 billion
or negative 2 billion looks like this
this is roughly the number 2 billion in
binary it's all ones with one zero way
over here if I count one second past
that two billion number give or take
that means like all right I add one I
carry the one it's just like nines
becoming zeros in decimal if I keep this
sort of simple animation and I keep
carrying the one carrying the one
carrying the one one second after two
billion seconds give or take I have this
number in the computer's memory so
there's still one bit that's a one all
the way to the left unfortunately that
bit often represents negativity
whereby if that first bit is negative
that represents that the rest of this
somehow represents a negative number
it's not negative zero there's a fancier
representation but a very big positive
number very suddenly becomes a very big
negative number and that number is
roughly negative two billion that means
computers in 2038 on that date are going
to accidentally think that it's been
negative two billion seconds since
January 1st 1970 which is going to make
computers potentially think it's 1901.
so what is the solution to the 2038
problem perhaps Y2K was because we were
using two digits for years what about
2038 more bits and thankfully we're
getting a little better at Lessons
Learned here and computers now are
increasingly using 64 bits and all of us
will be long gone by the time we run out
of that number of seconds so it's
someone else's problem many many years
from now but that's really the
fundamental solution if you're running
up against something finite well just
kick the can further and just give
yourself more bits and frankly because
Hardware is so much cheaper these days
computers are so much faster it's not as
big of a deal as it might have been
decades ago but that's indeed the
solution but this arises in very common
context in fact let me go ahead and
write a real quick program here called
pennies right you might think that just
converting Dollars to pennies in U.S
currency might be simple but let me go
ahead and do this in pennies.c I'm going
to go ahead and include cs50.h and I'm
going to include uh standard io.h int
main void as my start Turning Point
and now down here I'm going to do this
I'm going to get a float called amount
and I'm going to ask the user for some
amount of dollars so a dollar amount and
I'm going to store that in a variable
called amount then I'm going to Simply
convert that amount to pennies by doing
say how about uh
uh how about amount times 100 and then
I'm going to go ahead and print out that
the number of pennies
is percent I because that's just an
integer in pennies backslash n quote
unquote comma pennies
all right so if I didn't make any
mistakes here let me make pennies
dot slash pennies and suppose I have say
99 Cents so 0.99 that's 99 pennies
suppose I have a dollar twenty three
that's pretty good suppose I have four
dollars and 20 cents
huh there's that imprecision issue and
this isn't even that big of an amount
now not a big deal if like the cashier
gives you one penny less than your owed
but you can imagine this adding up you
can imagine this being worrisome for
financial implications
um for financial transactions for
scientific measurements that are like my
program can't even handle this well
there are some solutions here and it
looks like what's really happening if I
print it out using the percent f with a
0.50 or whatever to see more decimal
points presumably the computer is
struggling to represent four dollars and
twenty cents precisely it's probably
storing four dollars and
19.9999 something cents so it's close
but it's not quite there
so I could at least solve this by
rounding up for instance and it turns
out there is a round function out there
and it turns out that it's in a library
called the math library and you would
know this by looking at online
documentation and the like as we'll
point you to and if I now make pennies
again and do dot slash pennies I can now
do four dollars and twenty cents and
voila now it's correct so at least in
this context it seems like a solvable
problem but it's certainly something I
need to be mindful of nonetheless
unfortunately even professional
full-time programmers over the years
have not been particularly attentive to
these kinds of details and in a class
like this the goal is not just to teach
you programming but to really teach you
what's going on underneath the hood so
to speak so that you have a bottom-up
understanding of how data is represented
how computers are manipulating it so
that you are not on the failing end of
some program having some bug and so that
we as a society are not beholden to
those kinds of mistakes too and this
happens unfortunately all of the time
this is a Boeing airplane that a few
years ago needed to be rebooted after
every 248 days why because this Boeing
airplane software was using a 32-bit
integer counting up tenths of a second
to keep track of something or other
related to its electrical power and
unfortunately after 248 days of the
airplane being continuously on which in
the airline industry is apparently not
uncommon to make every dollar count
keeping the planes up and running all
the time the 32-bit number would roll
over and the power would shut off on the
airplane as a side effect because of
sort of undefined behavior in that case
the temporary Solution by voting at the
time was apparently essentially a sort
of operating system style well have you
rebooted your plane and that was indeed
the fix until they rolled out an actual
software patch this stuff really matters
and the more Hardware we carry around
and the more we as a society use these
kinds of devices the more of these
problems we're going to run into down
the road that's it for cs50 we'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50 and this is week two now
that you have some programming
experience under your belt in this more
Arcane language called C among our goals
today is to help you understand exactly
what you have been doing these past
several days wrestling with your first
programs in C so that you have more of a
bottom-up understanding of what some of
these commands do and ultimately what
more we can do with this language so
this recall was the very first program
you wrote I wrote in this language
called C much more textual certainly
than the scratch equivalent but at the
end of the day computers your Mac your
PC uh vs code doesn't understand this
actual code what's the format into which
we need to get any program that we write
just to recap
so so binary otherwise known as machine
code right the zeros and ones that your
computer actually does understand so
somehow we need to get to this format
and up until now we've been using this
command called make which is sort of
aptly named because it lets you make
programs and the invocation of that has
been pretty simple make hello sort of
looks in your current directory or
folder for a file called hello.c
implicitly and then it compiles that
into a file called hello which itself is
executable which just means runnable so
that you can then do dot slash hello but
it turns out that make is actually not a
compiler itself it does help you make
programs but make is this sort of
utility that comes on a lot of systems
that makes it easier to actually compile
code by using an actual compiler the
program that converts source code to
machine code on your own Mac or PC or
whatever Cloud environment you might be
using in fact what make is doing for us
is actually running a command
automatically known as clang for C
language and so in fact here for
instance in vs code is that very first
program again this time in the context
of a text editor and I could compile
this with make hello but let me go ahead
and use the compiler itself manually and
we'll see in a moment why we've been
automating the process with make I'm
going to run clang instead and then I'm
going to run hello.c so it's a little
different how the compiler is used it
needs to know explicitly what the file
is called I'll go ahead and run clang
hello.c enter nothing seems to happen
which generally speaking is a good thing
because no errors have popped up and if
I do LS now for list you'll see there is
not a file called hello but there is a
curiously named file called A.L this is
a historical convention stands for
assembler output and this is just the
default file name for a program that you
might compile yourself manually using
clang itself let me go ahead now though
and point out that that's kind of a
stupid name for a program even though it
works dot slash a DOT out would work but
if you actually want to customize the
name of your program we could just
resort to make or we could do explicitly
what make is doing for us because it
turns out some programs among them make
support what are called command line
arguments and more on those later today
but these are like literally words or
numbers that you type at your prompt
after the name of a program that just
influences Its Behavior in some way it
uh modifies Its Behavior and it turns
out if you read the documentation for
clang you can actually pass a dash o for
output command line argument that lets
you specify explicitly what do you want
your outputted program to be called and
then you go ahead and type the name of
the file that you actually want to
compile from source code to machine code
let me go ahead and hit enter now again
nothing seems to happen and I type LS
and voila now we still have the old a
DOT out because I didn't delete it yet
and I do have hello now so dot slash
hello voila runs hello world again and
let me go ahead and remove this file I
could of course resort to using the
Explorer on the left hand side which I
am in the habit of closing just to give
us more room to see see but I could go
ahead and right click or control click
on a DOT out if I want to get rid of it
or again let me focus on the command
line interface and I can use anyone
recall we didn't really use it much but
we'll command removes a file
RM so RM for remove RM a DOT out enter
remove regular file a DOT out y for yes
enter and now if I do LS again voila
it's gone all right so let's now enhance
this program to do the second version we
ever did which was to also include
cs50.h so that we have access to
functions like get string and the like
and let me go ahead and do string name
gets get string what's your name
question mark and now let me go ahead
and say hello to that name with our
percent s placeholder comma name so this
was version two of our program last time
that very easily compiled with make
hello but notice the difference now if I
want to compile this thing myself with
clang using that same lesson learned all
right let's do it clang Dash o hello
just so I get a better name for the
program
hello.c enter
and a new error pops up that some of you
might have encountered on your own so
it's a bit Arcane here and there's this
mention of a cryptic looking path with
temp for temporary there but somehow my
issues in Maine as we can see here uh it
somehow relates to hello.c even though
we might not have seen this language
last time in class but there's an
undefined reference to get string as
though get string doesn't exist now your
first instinct might be well maybe I
forgot cs50.h but of course I didn't
that's the very first line of my program
but it turns out make is doing something
else for us all this time just putting
cs50.h or any header file at the top of
your code for that matter just teaches
the compiler that a function will exist
it sort of asks the compiler to it asks
the compiler to trust that I will
eventually get around to implementing
functions like get string in cs50.h and
standard io.h like printf they're in
but this error here some kind of linker
command relates to the fact that there's
a separate process for actually finding
the zeros and ones that cs50 compiled
long ago for you that the authors of
this operating system compiled for you
long ago in the form of printf we need
to somehow tell the compiler that we
need to link in code that someone else
wrote the actual machine code that
someone else wrote and then compiled so
to do that you'd have to type dash lcs50
for instance at the end of the command
so additionally telling clang that not
only do you want to Output a file called
hello and you want to compile a file
called hello.c you also want to quote
unquote Link in a bunch of zeros and
ones that collectively Implement get
string and printf so now if I hit enter
this time it compiled OK and now if I
run dot slash hello it works as it did
last week
just like that but honestly this is just
going to get really tedious really
quickly notice already just to compile
my code I have to run clang Dash oh
hello hello Dot C Dash lcs50 and you're
gonna have to type more things too if
you wanted to use the math Library like
to use that round function you would
also have to do Dash LM typically to
specify give me the math bits that
someone else compiled and the commands
just get longer and longer so moving
forward we won't have to resort to
running clang itself but clang is indeed
the compiler that is the program that
converts from source code to machine
code but will continue to use make
because it just automates that process
and the commands are only going to get
more cryptic the more sophisticated and
more featureful your programs get and
make again is just a tool that makes all
that happen so to speak let me pause
there to see if there's any questions
before then we take a look further under
the hood yeah in front
[Music]
sure let me come back to that in a
moment what does the dash lcs50 mean
we'll come back to that visually in just
a moment but it means to link in the
zeros and ones that collectively
Implement get string and printf but
we'll see that visually in a sec yeah
behind you
[Music]
really good question how come I didn't
have to link in standard i o because I
use printf in version one standard I O
is just literally so standard that it's
built in it just works for free cs50 of
course is not it did not come with the
language C or the compiler we ourselves
wrote it and other libraries even though
they might come with the language C they
might not be enabled by default
generally for efficiency purposes so
you're not loading more zeros and ones
into the computer's memory than you need
to so standard i o is special if you
will other questions yeah
[Music]
oh what does the Des o mean so Dash o is
shorthand for the English word output
and so Dash o is telling clang to please
output a file called hello because the
next thing I wrote after the command
line recall was clang Dash o hello then
the name of the file then Dash lcs50 and
this is where these commands do get and
and stay fairly Arcane it's just through
muscle memory and practice that you'll
start to remember oh what are the other
commands that you what are the command
line arguments you can provide to
programs but we've seen this before
Technically when you run make hello the
program is called make hello is the
command line argument it's an input to
the make function albeit typed at the
prompt that tells make what you want to
make even when I used RM a moment ago
and did RM of a DOT out the command line
argument there was called a DOT out and
it's just telling RM what to delete it
is entirely dependent on the programs to
decide what their conventions are
whether you use Dash this or Dash that
but we'll see over time which ones
actually matter in practice so to come
back to the first question about what
actually is happening there let's
consider the code more closely up so
here is that first version of the code
again with standardio.h and only printf
so no cs50 stuff yet until we add it
back in it had the second version where
we actually get the human's name
when you run this command then there's
actually a few things that are happening
underneath the hood and we won't dwell
on these kinds of details indeed we'll
abstract it away so to speak by using
make but it's worth understanding at
least from the get-go how much
automation is going on so that when you
run these commands it's not magic you
actually do have this bottom-up
understanding of what's going on so when
we say you've been compiling your code
with make that's a bit of an
oversimplification technically every
time you compile your code you're having
the computer actually do four distinct
things for you and this is not four
distinct things that you need to sort of
memorize and remember every time you run
your program what's happening but it
helps to sort of break it down into
building blocks as to how we're getting
from source code like C into zeros and
ones it turns out that when you compile
quote unquote your code technically
speaking you're doing four things sort
of automatically and all at once
pre-processing it compiling it
assembling it and linking it just humans
decided let's just call the whole
process compiling but for a moment let's
just consider what these steps are are
so pre-processing refers to this if we
look at our source code here version 2
that uses the cs50 library and therefore
get string notice that we indeed have
these include lines at top and they're
kind of special versus all the other
code we've written because they start
with hash symbols specifically and
that's sort of a special syntax that
means that these are technically called
preprocessor directives fancy way of
saying they're handled special versus
the rest of your code in fact if we
focus on cs50.h recall from last week
that I provided a hint as to what's
actually in cs50.h among other things
like what was the one Salient thing that
I said was in cs50.h and therefore why
we were including it in the first place
so get strength specifically the
Prototype forget string we haven't made
many of our own functions yet but recall
that anytime we've made our own
functions and we've written them like
below Main in a file we've also had to
somewhat stupidly copy paste the
Prototype of the function at the top of
the file just to teach the compiler that
this function doesn't exist yet it does
down there but it will exist just trust
me so again that's what these prototypes
are doing for us so therefore in my code
if I want to use a function like get
string or printf for that matter
they're not implemented clearly in the
same file they're implemented elsewhere
so I need to tell the compiler to trust
me that they're implemented somewhere
else and so technically inside of cs50.h
which is installed somewhere in the
clouds hard drive so to speak that you
all are accessing via vs code there's a
line that looks like this a prototype
for the getstring function that says the
name of the function's get string it
takes one input or argument called
prompt
and that type of that prompt is a string
get string not surprisingly has a return
value and it returns a string so
literally that line and a bunch of
others are in cs50.h and so rather than
you all having to copy paste the
Prototype you can just trust that cs50
figured out what it is you can include
cs50.h and the compiler is going to go
find that prototype for you same thing
in standard i o someone else what must
clearly be in standard io.h among other
stuff that motivates our including
standard io.h2
yeah
printf the prototype for printf and
indeed I'll just change it here in
yellow to be the same and it turns out
the formats the prototype for printf is
actually pretty fancy because as you
might have noticed printf can take one
argument just something to print two if
you want to plug a value into it three
or more so the dot dot dot just
represents exactly that it's not quite
as simple a prototype as get string but
more on that another time so what does
it mean to pre-process your code the
very first thing the compiler clang in
this case is doing for you when it reads
your code top to bottom left to right is
it notices ooh here is Hash include oh
here's another hash include and it
essentially finds those files on the
hard drive cs50.h standardio.h and does
the equivalent of copying and pasting
them automatically into your code at the
very top thereby teaching the compiler
that get string and printf will
eventually exist somewhere so that's the
pre-processing step whereby again it's
just doing a find and replace of
anything that starts with hash include
it's plugging in the files there so that
you essentially get all the prototypes
you need automatically
okay what does it mean then to compile
the results because at this point in the
story your code now looks like this in
the computer's memory it doesn't change
your file it's doing all of this in the
computer's memory or RAM for you but it
essentially looks like this well the
next step is what's technically really
compiling even though again we use
compile as an umbrella term compiling
code in c means to take code that now
looks like this in the computer's memory
and turn it into something that looks
like this which is way more cryptic but
it was just a few decades ago that if
you were taking a class like cs50 in its
earlier form we wouldn't be using C if
it didn't exist yet we would actually be
using this something called Assembly
Language and there's different types of
or flavors of Assembly Language but this
is about as low level as you can get to
what a computer really understands be it
a Mac or PC or a phone before you start
getting into actual zeros and ones and
most of this is cryptic I couldn't
really tell you what this is doing
unless I really thought it through
carefully and rewound mentally years ago
from having studied it but let's
highlight a few key words in yellow
notice that this Assembly Language
that the computer is outputting for you
automatically still has mention of Main
and it has mention of get string and it
has mentioned of printf so there's some
relationship to the C code we saw a
moment ago and then if I highlight these
other things these are what are called
computer instructions at the end of the
day your Mac your PC your phone actually
only understands very basic instructions
like addition subtraction division
multiplication move into memory load
from memory print something to the
screen like very basic operations and
that's what you're seeing here these
assembly instructions are what the
computer actually feeds into the brains
of the computer the CPU the central
processing unit and it's that Intel CPU
or whatever you have that understands
this instruction and this one and this
one and this one and collectively long
story short all they do is print hello
world on the screen but in a way that
the machine understands how to do
[Music]
so let me pause here are there any
questions on what we mean by
pre-processing which just finds and
replaces the hash includes symbols among
others and and compiling which
technically takes your source code once
pre-processed and converts it to that
stuff called Assembly Language
[Music]
correct each type of CPU has its own
instruction set
indeed and as a teaser this is why at
least back in the day when we used to
like install software from CD-ROMs or
some other type of media this is why you
can't take a program that was sold for a
Windows computer and run it on a Mac or
vice versa because the commands the
instructions that those two products
understand are actually different now
Microsoft or any company could generally
write code in one language like C or
another and they can compile it twice
saving a PC version and saving a Mac
version it's twice as much work and
sometimes you get into some
incompatibilities but that's why these
steps are somewhat distinct you can now
use the same code and support even
different platforms or systems if you'd
want all right assembly assembly
thankfully this part is fairly
straightforward at least in concept to
assemble code which is step three of
four that is just happening literally
for you every time you run make or in
turn clang
this Assembly Language which the
computer generated automatically for you
from your source code is turned into
zeros and ones so that's the step that
last week I simplified and said when you
compile your code you convert it to
source code from source code to machine
code technically that happens when you
assemble your code but no one in normal
conversations says that they just say
compile for all of these terms
all right so that's
assembling there's one final step even
in this simple program of getting the
user's name and then plugging it into
printf I'm using three different
people's code if you will my own which
is in hello.c some of cs50s which is
apparently in hello.c and sorry which is
in
cs50.c which is not a file I've
mentioned yet but it stands to reason
that if there's a cs50.h that has
prototypes turns out the actual
implementation of get string and other
things are in cs50.c and there's a third
file somewhere on the hard drive so to
speak that's involved in compiling even
this simple program
hello.c
s50.c and by that logic what might the
other be
yeah
standardio.c and that's a bit of a white
lie because that's such a big fancy
library that there's actually multiple
files that compose it but the same ID
and we'll take the simplification so
when I have this code now and I compile
my code here I get those zeros and ones
that end up taking hello.c and turning
it effectively into zeros and ones that
are combined with cs50.c followed by
standardio.c as well so let me rewind
here here might be the zeros and ones
for my code the two lines of code
essentially that I wrote here might be
the zeros and ones for what cs50 wrote
some years ago in cs50.c here might be
the zeros and ones that someone wrote
for standard i o decades ago the last
and final step is that linking command
that links all of these zeros and ones
together essentially stitches them
together into one single file called
hello or called a DOT out whatever you
name it that last step is what combines
all of these different programmers zeros
and ones and my God like now we're
really in the weeds who wants to even
think about running code at this level
you shouldn't need to but it's not magic
when you're running make there's just
some very concrete steps that are
happening that humans have developed
over the years over the decades that
sort of break down this big problem of
source code going to zeros and ones or
machine code into these very specific
steps but henceforth you can call all of
this compiling
questions or confusion yeah
[Music]
sure what is a DOT out signify a DOT out
is just the conventional default file
name for any program that you compile
directly with a compiler like clang it's
just kind of a meaningless name though
it stands for assembler output an
assembler might now sound familiar from
this assembling process it's just kind
of a lame name for a computer program
and so we can override it by outputting
something like hello instead yeah
[Music]
foreign
so there are to recap there are other
prototypes in those files cs50.h
standard io.h technically they're all
included on top of your file even though
you strictly speaking don't need most of
them but indeed they are there just in
case you might want them
and finally any other questions yeah
[Music]
does it matter what order we're telling
the computer to run sometimes with
libraries yes it matters what order they
are linked in together but for our
purposes it's really not going to matter
it's just going to make is going to take
care of automating that process for us
all right so with that said henceforth
compiling technically is these four
things but we'll focus on it just as a
higher level concept and abstraction if
you will known as compiling itself so
another process that we'll now begin to
focus on all the more this week is
invariably this past week you ran
against uh ran up against some
challenges you probably created your
very first bugs or mistakes in a program
and so let's focus for a moment on
actual techniques for debugging as you
spend more time this semester in the
years to come if you continue to program
you're never frankly probably going to
write bug-free code ultimately your
programs are just going to get more
featureful more sophisticated and we're
all just going to start to make more
sophisticated mistakes and to this day I
write buggy code all the time and I'm
always horrified when I do it up here
but hopefully that won't happen too
often but when it does it's just a
process now of debugging trying to find
the mistakes in your program and you
don't have to just stare at your code or
sort of shake your fist at your code
there are actual tools that real world
programmers use to help debug their code
and find these faults so what are some
of the techniques and tools that folks
use well as an aside if you've ever
[Music]
bug in a program is a mistake that's
actually been around for some time if
you've ever heard this tale
um some 50 plus years ago in 1947 this
is actually an entry in a log book
written by famous computer scientist
known named Grace Hopper who happened to
be the one to record the very first
discovery of a quote unquote actual bug
in a computer this is actually like a
moth that had flown into at the time it
was a very sophisticated system known as
the Harvard Mark II computer sort of
very large sort of refrigerator size
type systems in which an actual bug
caused an issue
the animal bug though actually predates
this particular instance but here you
have is any computer scientist might
know the example of the first physical
bug in a computer
how though do you go about removing such
a thing well let's consider a very
simple scenario from last time for
instance when we're trying to print out
various aspects of Mario like this
column of three bricks let's consider
how I might go about implementing a
program like this and let me switch back
over to vs code here and I'm going to go
ahead and run uh write a program
and I'm not going to trust myself so I'm
going to call it buggy.c from the get-go
knowing that I'm going to mess something
up but I'm going to go ahead and include
standard io.h and I'm going to go ahead
and Define main as usual so hopefully no
mistakes just yet and now I want to
print those three bricks on the screen
using just hashes for bricks so how
about for INT I get zero I less than or
equal to 3 I plus plus now inside of my
curly braces I'm going to go ahead and
print out a hash followed by a backslash
n semicolon all right saving the file
doing make buggy enter it compiles so
there's no syntactical errors like my
code is syntactically correct but some
of you have probably seen The Logical
error already because when I run this
program I don't get this picture which
was three bricks High I seem to have
four bricks instead now this might be
jumping out at you why it's happening
but I've kept the program simple just so
that we don't have to actually find an
actual bug we can use a tool to find one
that we already know about in this case
what might be the first strategy for
actually finding a bug like this rather
than just staring at your code asking a
question trying to sort of just think
through the problem well let's actually
try to diagnose the problem more
proactively and the simplest way to do
this now and years from now is honestly
going to be used to use a function like
printf printf is a wonderfully useful
function not for formatting printing
formatted strings and all that but just
looking inside the values of variables
that you might be curious about to see
what's going on so you know what let me
do it do this I see that there's four
coming out but I intended three so
clearly something's wrong with my I
variables so let me just be a little
more pedantic let me go inside of this
Loop and just temporarily say something
explicit like I is percent I backslash n
and then just plug in the value of I
right this is not the program I want to
write it's the program I'm temporarily
writing because now I'm going to go
ahead and say make buggy dot slash buggy
and if I look now at the output I have
some helpful diagnostic information I is
0 and I get a hash I is 1 and I get a
hash two and I get a hash three and I
get half okay wait a minute I'm clearly
going too many steps because maybe I
forgot that computers are essentially
counting from zero and now oh it's less
than or equal to now you see it right
again trivial example but just by using
printf you can see inside of the
computer's memory by just printing stuff
out like this and now once you've
figured it out oh so this should
probably be less than three or I should
start counting from one there's any
number of ways I could fix this but the
most conventional is probably just to
say less than three now I can go ahead
and delete my temporary print statement
rerun make buggy dot slash buggy and
voila problem solved all right and to
this day I do this like whether it's
making a command line application or a
web application or a mobile application
it's very common to use printf or some
equivalent in any language just to poke
around and see what's inside the
computer's memory thankfully there's
more sophisticated tools than this let
me go ahead and reintroduce the bug here
and let me go ahead and reopen my
sidebar left here and let me go ahead
now and recompile the code to make sure
it's current and I'm going to run a
command called debug 50 which is a
command that's representative of a type
of program known as a debugger and this
debugger is actually built into vs code
and all debug 50 is doing for us it's
just automating the process of starting
vs codes built-in debugger so this isn't
even a cs50 specific tool we've just
given you a debug 50 command to make it
easier to start it up from the get-go
and the way you run this debugger is you
say debug 50 space and then the name of
the program that you want to debug so in
this case dot slash buggy so you don't
mention your C file you mentioned your
already compiled code and what this
debugger is going to let me do is most
powerfully walk through my code step by
step because every program we've written
thus far just kind of runs from start to
finish even if I'm not done sort of
thinking through each step at a time
with the debugger I can actually like
click on a line number and say pause
execution here and the debugger will let
me walk through my code one step at a
time one second at a time one minute at
a time at my own human pace which is
super compelling when the programs get
more complicated and they might
otherwise just fly by on the screen so
I'm going to click to the left of line
five and notice that these little red
dots appear and if I click on one it
stays and gets even redder and I'm going
to now run debug 50 on dot slash buggy
and in just a moment you'll see that a
new panel opens on the left hand side
it's doing some configuration of the
screen and now let me go ahead and zoom
out just a little bit here
so we can see more on the screen at once
and sometimes you'll see in vs code that
debug console opens up which looks very
cryptic just go back to terminal window
if that happens because at the terminal
window is where you can still interact
with your code and let's now take a look
at what's going on if I zoom in on my
buggy.c code here you'll notice that we
have
uh the same program as before but
highlighted in yellow is line five not a
coincidence that's the line I set a
so-called break point at the little sort
of Red Dot means break here pause
execution here and the yellow line has
not yet been executed but if I now at
the top of my screen notice these little
arrows there's one for play there's one
for this which if I hover over it says
step over there's another that's going
to say step into there's a third that
says step out I'm just going to use the
first of these step over and I'm going
to do this and you'll see that the
yellow highlight moved from line five to
line seven because now it's ready but
hasn't yet printed out that hash but the
most powerful thing here notice is that
top left here it's a little cryptic
because there's a bunch of things going
on that'll make more sense over time but
at the top there's a section called
variables below that something called
locals which means local to my current
function Main and notice there's my
variable called I and its current value
is zero so now once I click step over
again
Watch What Happens we go from line seven
back to line five but look in the
terminal window one of the hashes has
printed but now it's kind of printed at
my own pace I can sort of think through
this step by step notice that I has not
changed yet it's still zero because the
yellow highlighted line hasn't yet
executed but the moment I click step
over it's going to execute line five now
notice at top left I has become one
and nothing has printed yet because now
highlighted is line seven and so if I
click step over again we'll see the hash
and if I repeat this process at my own
human comfortable Pace I can see my
variables changing I can see output
changing on the screen and I can just
think about should that have just
happened and I can pause and give
thought to what's actually going on
without trying to race the computer and
figure it all out at once I'm going to
go ahead and just stop here because we
already know what this particular
problem is and that just brings me back
to my default terminal window but this
debugger let me disable the break point
now so it doesn't keep breaking this
debugger will be your friend moving
forward in order to step through your
code step by step at your own pace to
figure out where something has gone
wrong printf is great but it gets
annoying if you have to constantly add
print this print this print this print
this recompile re-run it oh wait a
minute print this print this like the
debugger just lets you do the equivalent
but automatically
questions on then this debugger which
you'll see all the more Hands-On over
time
questions on debugger yeah
you were using like a step over feature
what do the other features in this
really good question we'll see this
before long but those other buttons that
I glossed over like step into and step
out of actually let you step into
specific functions if I had any more
than main so if Maine called a function
called something and something called a
function called something else instead
of just stepping over the entire
execution of that function I could step
into it and walk through its lines of
code one by one so anytime you have a
problem set you're working on that has
multiple functions you can set a
breakpoint in main if you want or you
can set it inside of one of your
additional functions to focus your
attention only on that and we'll see
examples of that over time
all right so what else and what's the um
you know the sort of elephant in the
room so to speak is actually a duck in
this case why is there this duck in all
of these ducks here well it turns out a
third genuinely recommended debugging
technique is talking through problems
talking through code with someone else
now in the absence of having a family
member or a friend or a roommate who
actually wants to hear you talk about
code of all things
um generally programmers turn to a
rubber duck or other inanimate objects
uh if something animate is not available
and the idea behind rubber duck
debugging so to speak is that simply by
looking at your code
and talking it through okay on line
three I'm I'm starting a for Loop and
I'm initializing I to zero okay then I'm
printing out a hash just by talking
through your code step by step
invariably finds you having the
proverbial light bulb go off over your
head because you realize wait a minute I
just said something stupid or I just
said something wrong and this is really
just a proxy for any other human
teaching fellow teacher friend colleague
but in the absence of any of those
people in the room you're welcome to
take on your way out today one of these
little rubber ducks and consider using
it for real anytime you just want to
talk through one of your problems in
cs50 or maybe life more generally but
having it there on your desk is just a
way to help you hear ill logic in what
you think might otherwise be logical
code so printf debugging rubber duck
debugging are just three of the ways
you'll see over time to sort of get to
the source of code that you will write
that has mistakes which is going to
happen but it'll Empower you all the
more to solve of those mistakes
are any questions
on debugging in general or these three
techniques
yeah
what's the difference between step over
and step into at the moment the only one
that's applicable to the code I just
wrote is step over because it means step
over each line of code if though I had
other functions that I had written in
this program maybe lower down in the
file I could step into those function
calls and walk through them one at a
time so we'll come back to this with an
actual example but step into will allow
me to do exactly that in fact this is a
perfect segue to doing a little
something like this let me go ahead and
open up maybe another file here actually
we'll use the same buggy and we're just
going to write one other thing that's
buggy as well let me go ahead up here
and include as before cs50.h let me
include standard standard io.ah
let me do in main void so all of this I
think is correct so far and let's do
this let's give myself an INT called I
and let's ask the user for a negative
integer this is not a function that
exists technically yet but I'm going to
assume for the sake of discussion that
it does and then I'm just going to go
ahead and print out with percent I and a
new line whatever the human typed in so
at this point in the story my program I
think is correct except for the fact
that get Negative int is not a function
in the cs50 library or anywhere else I'm
going to need to invent it myself so
suppose in this case that I declare a
function called get Negative int uh its
return type so to speak should be int
because as its name suggests I want to
hand the user back an integer and it's
going to take no input to keep it simple
so I'm just going to say void there no
inputs no special prompts nothing like
that let me now give myself some curly
braces and let me do something familiar
perhaps now from problem set one let me
give myself a variable like n and let me
do the following
within this block of code assign n the
value of get int asking the user for a
negative integer using get in its own
prompt and I want to do this while n is
less than zero because I want to get a
negative int from the user and recall
from having used this block in the past
I can now return n as the very last step
to hand back whatever the user has typed
in so long as they cooperated and gave
me an actual negative integer now I've
deliberately made a mistake here and
it's a subtle sort of silly mathematical
one but let me compile this program
after copying now the Prototype up to
the top just so I don't make that
mistake again let me do make buggy enter
and now let me dot slash buggy I'll give
it a negative integer like negative 50.
uh huh that did not take uh how about
how about negative five maybe it's two
no uh how about zero
huh all right so it's clearly sort of
working backwards or incorrectly here
logically so how could I go about
debugging this well I could do what I've
done before I could use my printf10
technique and say something explicit
like n is percent I
new line comma I just sorry comma n just
to print it out let me recompile buggy
let me rerun buggy let me type in
negative 50. okay n is negative 50. so
that didn't really help me at this point
um because that's the same as before so
let me do this debug 50 dot slash buggy
oh but I've made a mistake so I didn't
set my break point yet so let me go
ahead and do this and I'll set a break
point this time I could set it here on
line eight let's do it in main as before
let me rerun debug 50 now on dot slash
buggy that's fancy user interface is
going to pop up it's going to highlight
the line that I set the break point on
notice that on the left hand side of the
screen I is defaulting at the moment to
zero because I haven't typed anything in
yet but let me go ahead now and step
over this line that's highlighted in
yellow
and you'll see that I'm being prompted
so let's type in my negative 50 enter
all right and notice now that
I'm stuck in that function so all right
so clearly the issue seems to be in my
get Negative int function so okay let me
go ahead and stop this execution my
problem doesn't seem to be in main per
se maybe it's down here so that's fine
let me set my same breakpoint at line
eight let me rerun debug 50 one more
time but this time instead of just
stepping over that line let's step into
it so notice line 8 is again highlighted
in yellow in the past I've been clicking
step over let's click step into now and
when I click step into boom now the
debugger jumps into that specific
function and now I can step through
these lines of code again and again I
can see what the value of n is as I'm
typing it in I can think through my
logic and voila hopefully once I've
solved the issue I can exit the debugger
fix my code and move on
so step over just goes over the line but
executes it step into lets you go into
other functions you've written
all right so let's go ahead and do this
we've got a bunch of possible approaches
that we can take to solving some problem
let's go ahead and Pace ourselves today
though let's take a five minute break
here and when we come back we'll
actually take a look at that computer's
memory we've been talking about see you
in five
all right
so let's
let's dive back in and up until now both
by way of week one and problem set one
for the most part we've just translated
from scratch and to see all of these
basic building blocks like loops and
conditionals Boolean Expressions
variables so sort of more of the same
but there are features in C that we've
already stumbled across already like
data types the types of variables that
doesn't exist in scratch but that in
fact does exist in other languages
inspect a few that we'll see before long
so to summarize the types we saw last
week just recall this little list here
we had in syn floats and Longs and
doubles and chars there's also bulls and
also string which we've seen a few times
but today let's actually start to
formalize what these things are and
actually like what your Mac and PC are
doing when you manipulate bits as an INT
versus a Char versus a string versus
something else and see if we can't put
more tools into your toolkit so to speak
so we can start quickly writing more
featureful more sophisticated programs
in C so it turns out that on most
systems nowadays though this can vary by
actual computer this is how large each
of the data types typically is in C when
you store Boolean value a zero or One A
true or a false or true it actually uses
one byte that's actually a little
excessive because strictly speaking you
only need one bit which is 1 8 of this
size but for Simplicity computers use a
whole byte to represent a bull true or
false a Char we saw last week is
actually only one byte or eight bits and
this is why ASCII which uses one byte or
technically only seven bits early on was
confined to only 256 maximally possible
characters notice that an INT is four
bytes or 32-bit 32 bits a float is also
four bytes or 32 bits but the things
that we called long it's literally twice
as long eight bytes or 64 bits and so is
a double a double is 64 bits of
precision for floating Point values and
a string for today we're going to leave
as a question mark because we'll come
back to that later today day and next
week as to how much space of string
takes up but suffice it to say it's
going to take up a variable amount of
space depending on whether the string is
short or long but we'll see exactly what
that means before long
so here's a photograph of a typical
piece of memory inside of your Mac or PC
or phone and odds are it might be just a
little smaller in some devices this is
known as Ram or random access memory and
each of these little black chips on this
circuit board the green thing these
little black chips are where zeros and
ones are actually stored each of those
stores some number of bytes maybe
megabytes maybe even gigabytes nowadays
so let's actually focus on just one of
those chips just to give us a sort of
zoomed in version thereof and let's
consider the fact that even though we
don't have to care exactly how this kind
of thing is made if this is like one
gigabyte of memory for the sake of
discussion it stands to reason that if
this thing is storing 1 billion bytes
one gigabyte then we can number them
kind of arbitrarily like maybe this will
be byte zero one two three four five six
seven eight and then maybe way down here
in the bottom right corner is byte
number one billion right we can just
number these things as might be our our
convention so let's actually draw that
graphically no with a billion squares
but fewer than those and let's just zoom
in further and consider that all right
at this point in the story let's
abstract away all the hardware and all
the little wires and just think of
memory as taking up a rather just think
of data as taking up some number of
bytes so for instance if you were to
store a Char in a computer's memory
which was one byte it might be stored
literally at this like top left-hand
location of this this black Chip of
memory if you were to store something
like an integer that uses four bytes
well it might use four of those bytes
but they're going to be contiguous back
to back to back in this case if it were
to store a long or a double you might
actually need eight bytes so I'm just
kind of filling in these squares to
represent how much memory and given
variable of some data type would take up
one or four or eight in this case here
well from here let's go ahead and just
abstract away from all of the hardware
and just really focus on memory as being
a grid or really like a canvas that we
can paint any types of data onto that we
want at the end of the day all of this
data is just going to be zeros and ones
but it's up to you and I to sort of
build abstractions on top of that things
like actual numbers and colors and
images and movies and Beyond but we'll
start lower level here first suppose I
had a program that needs three integers
like a simple program whose purpose in
life is to like average your three
scores on an exam or some such thing and
suppose that your three scores were the
72 and 73 not too bad and 33 which is
particularly low let's go ahead and
write a program that actually does this
kind of averaging for us let me go back
to vs code here let me open up a file
called scores.c
and let me go ahead and implement this
as follows let me include standard io.h
at the top int main void as before and
then inside of main let me go ahead and
declare score one which is 72 give me
another score uh 73 and then a third
score called score three which is going
to be 33 and now I'm just going to use
printf to print out the average of those
things and I can do this in a few
different ways but I'm going to just
print out percent F and I'm going to do
score one plus score two plus score 3
divided by three
close parenthesis semicolon so just some
relatively simple arithmetic just to
compute the average of three scores if
I'm curious like what my average grade
is in the class with these three
assessments all right let me go ahead
now and do make scores
huh all right so I've somehow made an
error already but this one is actually
germane to a problem we
hopefully won't can counter too
frequently what's going on here so
underline to score one plus score two
plus score three divided by three format
specifies type double but the argument
has Type int
well what's going on here because the
arithmetic seems to check out yeah
[Music]
correct and we'll come back to this in
more detail but indeed What's Happening
Here is I'm adding three ins together
obviously because I Define them right up
here and I'm dividing by another ant
three but the catches recall that c when
it performs math treats all of these
things as integers but integers are not
floating Point values so if you actually
want to get a precise average for your
score without throwing away the
remainder everything after the decimal
point it turns out in this case we're
going to have to we're going to oh we're
gonna have to we're gonna have to
convert this whole expression somehow to
a float and there's a few ways to do
this but the easiest way for now I'm
just going to go ahead and do this up
here I'm going to change the divide by 3
to divide by 3.0 because it turns out
long story short in C so long is one of
the values participating in an
arithmetic expression like this is
something like a float the rest will be
treated as promoted to so to speak a
floating point value as well so let me
now recompile this code code with make
scores enter this time it worked okay
because I'm treating a float as a float
and let me dot slash scores enter all
right my average is
59.333333 and so forth all right so the
math presumably checks out floating
point in Precision per last week aside
but let's consider the design of this
program like what is kind of
bad about it or if we maintain this
program longer term are we going to
regret the design of this program
what might not be ideal here yeah
[Music]
yeah so in this case I have hard-coded
my three score so if I'm hearing you
correctly uh this program is only ever
going to tell me this specific average
I'm not even using something like get
int or get flow to get three different
scores so that's not good and suppose
that we wait later in the semester I
think other problems could arise yeah
[Music]
I can't reuse the number because I
haven't stored the average in some
variable which in this program not a big
deal but certainly if I wanted to reuse
it elsewhere that's a problem and let's
fast forward again a little later in the
semester I don't just have three test
scores or exam scores maybe I have four
or five or six where might this take us
[Music]
yeah I've sort of capped this program at
three and honestly this is just kind of
bordering on copy paste even though the
variables yes have different names score
one score two score three imagine doing
this for like a whole grade book for a
class having score four five six eleven
ten twelve twenty Thirty like that's a
lot of variables and you can imagine
just how ugly the code starts to get if
you're just defining variable after
variable after variable so it turns out
there are better ways in languages like
C if you actually want to have multiple
values stored in memory that happen to
be of the same data type and so let's
take a look back at this memory here to
see what these things might look like in
memory here's that grid of memory and
each of these recall represents a byte
so just to be clear if I store score one
in memory first how many bytes will it
take up
so four AKA 32 bits so I might draw
score one as filling up this part of the
memory it's really up to the computer as
to whether it goes here or down there or
wherever I'm just keeping the pictures
clean though for today from the top left
on down if I then declare another
variable called score two it might end
up over there also taking up four bytes
and then score three might end up here
and so that's just representing what's
going on inside of the computer's memory
but technically speaking to be clear per
week zero What's really being stored in
the computer's memory are patterns of
zeros and ones 32 total in this case
because 32 bits is four bytes but again
it sort of gets boring quickly to think
at think in and look at binary all the
time so we'll generally abstract this
away as just using decimal numbers in
this case instead but there might be a
better way to store not just three of
these things but maybe four maybe five
maybe ten maybe more by declaring one
variable to store all of them instead of
three or four or five or more individual
variables and the way to do this is by
way of something generally known as an
array an array is another type of data
that allows you to store
multiple values of the same type back to
back to back that is to say contiguously
so an array can let you create memory
for one int or two or three or even more
than that but describe them all using
the same variable name the same one name
so for instance if for one program I
only need three integers but I don't
want to sort of
uh messily declared them as score one
score two score three I can actually do
this instead and this is today's first
new piece of syntax the square brackets
that we're now seeing this line of code
here is similar to int score one
semicolon or int score one equals 72
semicolon this line of code is declaring
for me so to speak an array of size
three and that array is going to store
three integers why because the type of
that array
is an INT here the square brackets tell
the computer how many inch you want in
this case three and the name is of
course scores which in English I've just
deliberately pluralized now so that I
can describe this array as storing
multiple scores indeed so if I want to
now assign values to this variable
called scores I can do code like this I
can say scores bracket zero equals 72
scores bracket 1 equals 73 and scores
bracket 2 equals 33. the only thing
weird there is admittedly the square
brackets which are still new but we're
also notice zero indexing things to zero
index means to start counting at zero
and we've talked about that before our
for Loops have generally been zero
indexed arrays in C
are zero indexed and you do not have
Choice over that you can't just start
counting it one in arrays just because
you prefer to you'd be sacrificing one
of the elements you have to start an
arrays counting from zero
so out of context this doesn't
necessarily solve a problem but it
definitely is going to once we have more
than even three scores here in fact let
me go ahead and change this program a
little bit let me go back to vs code
here and let me go ahead and delete
these three lines here and let me
replace it with a scores variable that's
ready to store three total integers and
then let me go ahead and initialize them
as follows scores bracket zero is 72 as
before scores bracket one is going to be
73 scores bracket 2 is going to be 33.
notice I do not need to say int before
any of these lines because that's been
taken care of already for me on line
five where I already specified that
everything in this array is going to be
an INT
now down here this code needs to change
because I no longer have three variables
score one two and three I have one
variable but that I can index into
I'm going to here then do scores bracket
zero plus scores bracket one plus scores
bracket two which is equivalent to what
I did earlier giving me back those three
integers but notice I'm using the same
variable name every time and again I'm
using this new square bracket notation
to quote unquote index into the array to
get at the first int the second int and
the third and then to do it again down
here now this program's still not really
solving all the problems we described
like I still can only store three scores
but we'll come back to something like
that before long but for now we're just
introducing a new syntax and a new
feature whereby I can now store multiple
values in the same variable
well let's enhance this a bit more
instead of hard coding these scores as
was identified as a problem let's go
ahead and use get int to ask the user
for a score let's then use get int to
ask the user for another score let's use
get int to ask the user for a third
score storing them in those respective
locations and now if I go ahead and save
this program recompile scores
huh I've messed up here but now these
errors should be getting a little
familiar what mistake did I make
let me give folks a moment
cs50.h so that was not intentional so
still making mistakes all these years
later I need to include cs50.h now I'm
going to go back to the bottom in the
terminal window make scores okay we're
back in business dot slash scores now
the program's getting a little more
interesting so maybe this year was
better and I got a 199 and a 98 and
there my average is
99.000. so now it's a little more
Dynamic so it's a little more
interesting but it's still capping the
number of scores at three admittedly but
now I've kind of introduced another
sort of symptom of bad programming
there's this expression in programming
too called code smell where like
something smells a little off and
there's something off here in that I
could do better with this code here does
anyone see an opportunity to improve the
design of this code here if my goal
still is just to get three scores from
the user but without it like smelling
kind of bad yeah
[Music]
yeah exactly those lines of code are
almost identical and honestly the only
thing that's changing is the number and
it's just incrementing by one we have
all of the building blocks to do this
better so let me go ahead and improve
this let me go ahead and delete that
code let me go ahead now and have a for
Loop so for INT I get zero I less than
three I plus plus then inside of this
for loop I can distill all three of
those lines into something more generic
like scores bracket I equals get int and
now ask the user just once if I get into
four score so this is where arrays start
to get pretty powerful you don't have to
hard code that is literally type in all
of these magic numbers like zero one and
two you can start to do it
programmatically as you propose with a
loop so now I've kind of tightened
things up I'm now dynamically getting
three different scores but putting them
in three different locations and so this
program ultimately is going to work
pretty much the same make scores dot
slash scores and 199 98 and we're back
to the same answer but it's a little
better design too if I really want to
nitpick there's something that still
smells a little bit here the fact that I
have indeed this magic number three here
that really kind of has to be the same
as this number here otherwise who knows
what's going to go wrong so what might
be a solution per last week to kind of
cleaning that code up further too
okay so we could leave it up to the
user's discretion and so we could
actually do something like this let me
take this a few steps ahead let me say
something like int and get get int how
many scores question mark then I could
actually change this to an n and then
this to an end and indeed make the whole
program Dynamic ask the human how many
tests have there been this semester then
you can type in each of those scores
because the loop is going to iterate
that many times and then you'll get the
average of one test two test three I
lost another
or however many scores that were
actually specified by the user
Yeah question
[Music]
how how many bytes are used in an array
uh so the purpose of an array is not to
save space it's to eliminate having
multiple variable names because that
just gets very messy quickly if you
literally have score one score two score
three dot dot score 99 that's literally
like 99 different variables potentially
that you could actually collapse into
one variable that has 99 locations if
you will at different indices or indexes
as someone would say the index for an
array is whatever's in the square
brackets
thank you
[Music]
so it's a good question so if you I'm
using ins for everything and honestly we
don't really need ants for scores
because I'm not really likely to get a 2
billion on a test anytime soon and so
you could actually use different data
types and that list we had on the screen
earlier is not all of them there's
actually a data type called short which
is literally shorter than an INT you
could actually technically use Char in
some form or even other data types as
well generally speaking in the year 2021
these tend to be over overly optimized
uh decisions like everyone just uses ins
even though no one's going to get a test
score that's 2 billion or more because
int is just kind of the go-to years ago
memory was expensive and every one of
your instincts would have been spot on
because memory is so tight but nowadays
we don't worry as much about it yeah
[Music]
uh so what is the difference between
dividing two ins and not getting an
error as you might have encountered in a
program like cash versus dividing two
ants and getting an error like I did a
moment ago the problem with the scenario
I created moment ago was printf was
involved and I was telling printf to use
a percent F but I was giving printf the
result of dividing integers by another
integer so it was printf that was
yelling at me and I'm guessing in the
scenario you're describing for something
like cash printf was not involved in
that particular line of code so that's
the difference there
all right so we now have this ability to
create uh an array and an array can
store multiple values what then might we
do that's more interesting than just
storing numbers in memory well let's
take this one step further as opposed to
just storing 72 73 33 or 199.98 at these
given locations because again an array
gives you one variable name but multiple
locations or indices they're in bracket
zero bracket one bracket two on up if it
were even bigger than that let's now
start to consider something more modest
like simple chars chars being one byte
each so they're even smaller they take
up much less space and indeed if I
wanted to say a message like hi I could
use three variables if I wanted a
program to print high h i exclamation
point literally I could of course store
those in three variables like C1 C2 C3
and let's just for the sake of
discussion let's go ahead and whip this
up real quickly let me create a new
program here now in vs code this time
I'm going to call it High Dot C and I'm
not going to bother with the cs50
library here I just need the standard i
o one for now int main void and then
inside of main I'm going to Simply
create three variables and this is
already hopefully striking you as a bad
idea but we'll go down this road
temporarily with C1 and C2 and finally
C3 storing each character in the phrase
I want to print and I'm going to go
ahead now and print this in a different
way than usual now I'm doing with chars
and we've generally dealt with strings
which was easier certainly last week but
percent C percent C percent C well let
me print out three chars and like C1 C2
and C3 so kind of a stupid way of
printing out a string so we already have
a solution to this problem last week but
let's just poke around at what's
actually going on underneath the hood
here so let's make High dot slash high
and voila no surprise but we again could
have done this last week with a string
and just one variable or even zero at
that but let's go ahead now and start
converting these characters to their
apparent numeric equivalents like we
talked about in week zero two let me go
ahead and modify these percent C's just
to be fun to be percent I's and let me
just add some spaces so that there are
gaps between each of them let me now
recompile High
and let me rerun it and just to guess
what should I see on the screen now
and he guesses yeah
the ASCII values and it's intentional
that I keep using the same word hi
because it should be hopefully the old
friends 72 73 and 33 which is to say
that c knows about ASCII or equivalently
Unicode and can do this conversion for
us automatically and it seems to be
doing it implicitly for us so to speak
notice that C1 C2 and C3 are obviously
charged but printf is able to tolerate
printing them as integers if I really
want it to be pedantic I could use this
technique again known as type casting
where I can actually convert one data
type to another if it makes logical
sense to do so and at the end of the day
we saw in week zero chars or characters
are just numbers like 72 73 and 33 so I
can actually use this parenthetical
expression to convert incorrectly three
chars to three integers instead so
that's what I meant to type the first
time there we go strike two today so
parenthesis and close parenthesis just
says take whatever variable comes after
this C1 or C2 or C3 and convert it to an
INT the effect is going to be no
different here make high and then
re-running whoops then running dot slash
High still works the same but now I'm
explicitly converting chars to ins and
we can do this all day long charge to
ins floats to ins insta floats sometimes
it's equivalent other times you're going
to lose information taking a float to an
INT just intuitively is going to throw
away everything after the decimal point
because after all an INT has no decimal
point but for now I'm going to go ahead
and Rewind to the version of this that
just did implicit type conversion or
implicit casting just to demonstrate
that we can indeed see the values
underneath the hood all right let me go
ahead and do this now the week one way
this was kind of stupid let's just do
printf quote unquote
actually let's do this string s equals
quote unquote high and then let's go
ahead and do a simple printf with
percent s printing out s is there so now
I've rewound to last week where we began
this story but you'll notice that if we
keep playing around with this whoops uh
what did I do here oh and let me
introduce the cs50 library here more on
that before long let me go ahead and
recompile re-run this we seem to be
coding in circles here like I've just
done the same thing multiple different
ways but there's clearly an equivalence
then between sequences of chars and
strings and if you do it the real
pedantic way you have like three
different variables C1 C2 C3
representing Hi exclamation point or you
can just treat them all together like
this h i exclamation point but it turns
out that strings are actually
implemented by the computer in a pretty
now familiar way
what might a string actually be as of
this point in the story
where are we going with this let me try
to look farther back in way back yeah
yeah a string might be and indeed is
just an array of characters so last week
we just took for granted that strings
exist technically strings exist but
they're implemented as arrays of
characters which actually opens up some
interesting possibilities for us because
let me see let me see if I can do this
let me try to print out now three
integers again but if string s is but an
array as you propose maybe I can do s
bracket zero s bracket one and S bracket
two so maybe I can start poking around
inside of strings even though we didn't
do this last week so I can get at those
individual values so make High Dot slash
high and voila there we go again it's
the same 72 73 33 but now I'm sort of
hopefully like wrapping my mind around
the fact that all right a string is just
an array of characters an arrays you can
index into them using this new square
bracket notation so I can get it any one
of these individual characters and heck
convert it to an integer like we did in
week zero as I might
but let me get a little curious now too
what might what else might be in the
computer's memory well let's toggle back
to the the depiction of these same
things here might be how we originally
implemented high with three variables C1
C2 C3 of course that map to these
decimal digits or equivalent these
binary values but what was this looking
like in memory literally when you create
a string in memory like this string s
equals quote unquote High let's consider
what's going on underneath the hood so
to speak well as an abstraction a string
it's h i exclamation point taking up it
would seem three bytes right I've gotten
rid of the bars there because if you
think of a string as a type I'm just
going to use one big box of size three
but technically
a string we've just revealed is an array
and the array is of size three so
technically if the string is called s s
bracket zero will give you the first
character s bracket one the second and S
bracket three the Third
but let me ask this question now if this
at the end of the day is the only thing
in your computer memory and the ability
like a canvas to draw zeros and ones or
numbers or characters or whatever on it
but that's it like this is what your Mac
and PC and phone ultimately reduced to
suppose that I'm running a piece of
software like a text messenger and now I
write down by exclamation point well
where might that go in memory well it
might go here b y e and then the next
thing I type I go here here here and so
forth my memory just might get filled up
over time with things that you or
someone else are typing
but then how does the computer know if
potentially b y e exclamation point is
right after h i exclamation point where
one string ends and the next one begins
right all we have are bytes or zeros in
one so if you were designing this how
would you implement some kind of
delimiter between the two or figure out
what the length of a string is what do
you think
okay so the right answer is use a null
character and for those who don't know
what does that mean
yeah so it's a special character let me
describe it as a sentinel character
humans decided some time ago that you
know what if we want to delineate where
one string ends and where the next one
begins we just need some special symbol
and the symbol they'll use is generally
written as backslash zero this is just
shorthand notation for literally eight
zero bits zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero and the nickname for eight
zero bits in this context is null n-u-l
so to speak and we can actually see this
as follows if you look at the
corresponding decimal digits like you
could do by just doing out the math or
doing the conversion like we've done in
code you would see for storing High 72
73 33 but then one extra byte that's
sort of invisibly there but that is all
zeros and now I've just written it as
the decimal number zero the implication
of this is that the computer is
apparently using not three bytes to
store a word like hi
but four bytes whatever the length of
the string is plus one for this special
Sentinel value that demarcates the end
of the string so we might draw it like
this instead and this character is again
sort of pronounced null or written n-u-l
so that's all right if humans at the end
of the day just have this canvas of
memory they just needed to decide all
right well how do we distinguish one
string from another because it's a lot
easier with chars individually it's a
lot easier with ins it's even easier
with floats why because per that chart
earlier every character is always one
byte every int is always four bytes
every Wong is always eight bytes how
long is a string well high is one two
three with an exclamation point bi is
one two three four with an exclamation
point David is d-a-v-i-d5 without an
exclamation point and so a string can be
any number of uh bytes long so you
somehow need to draw a line in the sand
to separate in memory one string from
another her
so what's the implication of this well
let me go back to code here let's
actually poke around this is a bit
dangerous but I'm going to start looking
at memory locations past my string here
so let me go ahead and recompile uh make
High
whoops what did I do here oh I forgot a
format code let me add one more percent
I
now let me go ahead and rerun make High
Dot slash High enter there it is so you
can actually see in the computer
unbeknownst to you previously that
there's indeed something else going on
there and if I were to make like one
other variant of this program let's get
rid of just this one word and Libby
let's have two so let me give myself
another string called t for instance
just just this common convention with by
exclamation point let me then go ahead
and print out with percent s s and let
me also print out with percent s whoops
print F print out t as well let me just
recompile this program and obviously the
out this is what happens when I go too
fast
all right third mistake today close
quote as I was missing make High
fourth mistake today make High Dot slash
High okay voila now we have a program
that's printing both high and by only so
that we can consider what's going on in
the computer's memory if s is storing
high and apparently one bonus byte that
demarcates the end of that string bi is
apparently going to fit into the
location directly after and it's
wrapping around but that's just an
artist's rendition here but bye
exclamation point is taking up one two
three four plus a fifth byte
as well
all right any questions on this
underlying representation of strings and
will contextualize this before long so
that this isn't just like okay who
really cares this is going to be the
source of actually implementing things
in fact for problems that too like
cryptography and encryption and actually
scrambling actual human messages but
some questions first
[Music]
a good question too and let me summarize
as if we were instead to use chars all
the time we would indeed have to know in
advance how many charge you want for a
given string that you're storing how
then does something like get string work
because when cs50 wrote the get string
function we obviously don't know how
long the words are going to be that you
all are typing in it turns out next uh
two weeks from now we'll see that get
string uses a technique known as dynamic
memory allocation and it's going to grow
or Shrink the array uh automatically for
you but more on that soon other
questions
about
that good question why are we using a
null value isn't it wasting a bite yes
but I claim there's really no other way
to distinguish the end of one string
from the start of another unless we make
some sort of Mark uh notation so to
speak in memory all we have at the end
of the day inside of a computer are bits
therefore all we can do is spin those
bits in some creative way to solve this
problem and so we're minimally going to
spend one byte to solve this problem
here yeah
[Music]
slash and if we don't have it or
if you don't how does a the computer
know to move to a next line when you
have a backslash and so backslash n even
though it looks like two characters it's
actually stored as just one byte in the
computer's memory there's a mapping
between it and an actual number and you
can see that for instance on the ASCII
chart from the other day
[Music]
it would be if I had put a backslash n
in my code here right after the
exclamation point here and here that
would actually shift everything in
memory because we would need to make
room for a backslash in here and another
one over here so it would take two more
bytes exactly other questions
my exclamation point is
72 733 if we are to write those numbers
in the screen and
how will the computer know what's 72 and
what's a
and what's the last thing you said
it's context sensitive so if at the end
of the day all we're storing is these
numbers like 72 73 33 recall that it's
up to the program to decide based on
context how to interpret them and I
simplified this story in week zero
saying that photoshop interprets them as
RGB colors and iMessage or a text
messaging program interprets them as uh
letters and Excel interprets them as
numbers
how those programs do it is by way of
variables like string and int and float
and in fact later this semester we'll
see a data type via which you can
represent a color as a triple of numbers
and red value a green value and a blue
value so we'll see other data types as
well yeah
[Music]
really interesting question why could we
not just make all data types variable in
size in some languages some libraries do
exactly this C is an older language and
so because memory was expensive memory
was limited the reality was you gain
benefits from just standardizing the
size of these things you also get
performance increases in the sense that
if you know every int is four bytes you
can very quickly and we'll see this next
week jump from integer to another to
another in memory just by adding four
inside of those square brackets you can
very quickly poke around whereas if you
had variable length numbers you would
have to kind of follow follow looking
for the end of it follow follow you
would have to look at more locations in
memory so that's a topic we'll come back
to but it was generally for efficiency
and other question yeah
[Music]
good question why not store the okay
same one why not store the null
character at the beginning uh you could
I uh let's see if why not store it at
the beginning
you could do that
um you could absolutely well could you
do this
[Music]
if you were to do that at the beginning
short answer no okay no I retract that
no I because I finally thought of a
problem with this if you store it at the
beginning instead we'll see in just a
moment how you can actually write code
to figure out where the end of a string
is and the problem there is you wouldn't
necessarily know if you eventually hit a
zero at the end of the string because
it's the number zero in the context of
like Excel using some memory or if it's
the context of some other data type
altogether so the fact that we've
standardized the fact that we've
standardized strings as ending with null
means that we can reliably distinguish
one variable from another in memory and
that's actually a perfect segue not
actually using this primitive to
building up our own code that
manipulates these things at a lower
level so let me go ahead and do this let
me create a new file this time called
length and let's just use this basic
idea to figure out what the length of a
string is after uh it's been stored in a
variable here so let's go ahead and do
this let me include both the cs50
header and the standard i o header give
myself int main void again here and
inside of main let me go ahead and do
this let me prompt the user for a string
s and I'll ask them for a string like
their name here
and then let me go ahead and actually
let me name it more verbosely name this
time and now let me go ahead and do this
let me iterate over every character in
this string in order to figure out what
its length is so initially I'm going to
go ahead and say this int length equals
zero because I don't know what it is yet
so we're going to start at zero and then
while the following is true while
let me do I want to do this
let me change this to I just for clarity
let me go ahead and do this while name
bracket I does not equal that special
null character so I typed it on the
slide as nul but you don't write nul in
code you actually use its numeric
equivalent which is backslash zero in
single quotes while
name bracket I does not equal the null
character I'm going to go ahead and
increment I to I plus plus and then down
here I'm going to print out the value of
I to see what we actually get printing
out the value of I alright so what's
going to happen here let me go ahead and
run make length fortunately no errors
dot slash length and let me type in
something like Hi exclamation point
Enter
and I get three let me try by
exclamation point Enter and I get four
let me try my own name David enter 5 and
so forth so what's actually going on
here well it seems that by way of this
for Loop we are specifying a local
variable called I initialized to zero
because we're figuring out the length of
the string as we go I'm then asking the
question does location zero that is I in
the name
string which we now know is an array
does it not equal backslash zero because
if it doesn't that means it's an actual
character like H or b or d so let's
increment I then let's come back around
to line nine and let's ask the question
again now I equals one so does name
bracket one not equal backslash zero
well if it doesn't and it won't if it's
an i or a y or an A based on what I
typed in we're going to increment I once
more fast forward to the end of the
story once I get to the end of the
string technically one space
past the end of the string name bracket
I will equal backslash zero so I don't
increment I anymore I end up just
printing the result so what we seem to
have here with some low level C code
just this while loop is a program that
figures out the length of a given string
that's been typed in let's practice our
abstraction and decompose this into
maybe a helper function here let me
actually grab all of this code here and
let me assume for the sake of discussion
for a moment that I can just call a
function now called string length and
the length of the string is name that I
want to get and then I'll go ahead and
print out just as before with percent I
the length of that string so now I'm
abstracting away this notion of figuring
out the length of the string that's an
opportunity for demi to create my own
function if I want to create a function
called string length I'll claim that I
want to
take a string as input
and what should I have this function
return as its return type
what should get string presumably return
but yeah
an inch right and it makes sense float
really wouldn't make sense because we're
measuring things that are uh integers in
this case the length of something so
indeed let's have it return an INT I can
pretty much use the same code as before
so I'm just going to paste what I cut
earlier in the file and the only thing I
have to change here is the name of the
variable because now this function I
decided kind of arbitrarily that I'm
going to call it s just to be more
generic so I'm going to look at s
bracket I at each location and I don't
want to print it at the end this would
be a side effect what's the line of code
I should include here if I actually want
to hand back the total length yeah
say again
return I in this case so I'm going to go
ahead and return I not print it because
now my main function can use the return
value stored in length and print it on
the next line itself I just need a
prototype so that's my one forgivable
copy paste here I'm going to rerun make
length hopefully I didn't screw up I
didn't dot slash length I'll type in hot
oops I'll type in high again
that works I'll type in buy again and so
forth all right so now we have a
function that determines the length of a
string well it turns out we didn't
actually need this all along it turns
out that we can get rid of my own custom
string length function here I can
definitely delete the whole
implementation down here because it
turns out in a file called string.h
which is a new header file today we
actually have access to a function
called more succinctly Sterling
s-t-r-l-e-n which literally does that
this is a function that comes with C
albeit in the string.h header file and
it does pretty much what we just
implemented manually so here's an
example of admittedly a wheel we just
reinvented but no more we don't have to
do that and how do you know what kinds
of functions exist well let me actually
pop out of my browser here to a website
that is a cs50s incarnation of what are
called manual pages it turns out that in
a lot of systems Macs and Unix and Linux
systems including the visual studio code
instance that we have in the cloud there
are publicly accessible manual pages for
functions they tend to be written very
expertly in a way that's not very
beginner friendly so what we have here
at manual.cs50.ao is cs50s version of
manual pages that have this less
comfortable mode that give you a sort of
cheat sheet of very frequently used
helpful functions in C and we've
translated the sort of expert notation
to things that a beginner can understand
so for instance let me go ahead and
search for string up at the top here
you'll see that there's documentation
for our own get string function but more
interestingly down here there's a whole
bunch of string related functions that
we haven't even seen most of yet but
there's indeed one here called Sterling
calculate the length of a string and so
if I actually go to Sterling here I'll
see some less comfortable documentation
for this function and the way a manual
page typically Works whether in cs50s
format or any other system is you see
typically a synopsis of what header
files you need to use the function so
you would copy paste these couple of
lines here you see what the Prototype is
of the function so that you know what
its inputs are if any and its outputs
are if any then down below you might see
a description which in this case is
pretty straightforward this function
calculates the length of s then you see
what the return value is if any and you
might even see an example like this one
that we've whipped up here so these
manual pages which are again accessible
here and we'll link to these in the
problems that's moving forward are
pretty much the place to start when you
want to figure out has a wheel been
invented already is there a function
that might help me solve some problem
set problem so that I don't have to
really get into the weeds of doing all
of those lower level steps as I've had
sometimes the answer is going to be yes
sometimes it's going to be no but again
the point of our having just done this
together is to feel that even the
functions you start taking for granted
they all reduce to some of these basic
building blocks at the end of the day
this is all that's inside of your
computer is zeros and ones we're just
learning now how to harness those and
how to manipulate them
ourselves
all right any questions here
on this
any questions at all
[Music]
good question is it so common that you
would have to specify it or not you do
need to include its header files because
that's where all of those prototypes are
you don't need to worry about linking it
in with Dash L anything and in fact
moving forward you do not ever need to
worry about linking in libraries when
compiling your code we the staff have
configured make to do all of that for
you automatically we want you to
understand that it is doing it but we'll
take care of all of the dash L's for you
but the onus is on you for the
prototypes and the header files other
questions
on these representations or techniques
yeah
[Music]
oh good question if you you were to have
a string with actual spaces in it that
is multiple words what would the
computer actually do well for this let
me go to asciiart.com which is just a
random website that's my go-to for the
first 127 characters of ASCII um this is
in fact what we had a screenshot of the
other day and if you look here it's a
little non-obvious but SP is space if a
computer were to store a space it would
actually store the decimal number 32 or
technically the pattern of zeros and
ones that represent the number 32. all
of the US English keys that you might
type on a keyboard can be represented
with a number and using Unicode can you
express even things like emojis and
other languages yeah
[Music]
good question only strings are
accompanied by nulls at the end because
every other data type we've talked about
thus far is of well-defined finite
length one byte for Char four bytes for
ants and so forth if we think back
though the last week we did end the week
with a couple of problems integer
overflow because like four bytes heck
even eight bytes is sometimes not enough
we also talked about floating point and
precision thankfully in the world of
scientific Computing and financial
Computing there are libraries you can
use that draw inspiration from this idea
of a string and they might use nine
bytes for an integer value or maybe 20
bytes You Can Count really high but they
will then start to manage that memory
for you and what they're really probably
doing is just grabbing a whole bunch of
bytes and somehow remembering how long
the sequence of bytes is that's how
these higher level libraries work too
all right this has been a lot let's take
one more break here we'll do like a
seven minute break here and when we come
back we'll flesh out a few more details
all right
so we just saw Sterling as an example of
a function that comes in the string
library and let's start to take more of
these Library functions out for a spin
so we're not relying only on the
built-ins that we saw last week let me
go ahead and switch over to vs code and
let me create a file called say string.h
just to kind of apply this lesson
learned as follows let me go ahead and
include cs50.h let me include standard
io.h and this new thing string.h as well
at the top I'm going to do the usual int
main void here and then in this program
suppose for the sake of discussion that
I didn't know about percent s for printf
or heck maybe early on there was no
percent s format code and so there was
no easy way to print strings well at
least if we know that strings are just
arrays of characters we could use
percent c as a workaround so to speak a
solution to that sort of contrived
problem so let me ask myself for a
string s by using get string here and
I'll ask the user for some inputs and
and then let me go ahead and print out
say output and all I want to do is print
back out what the user typed now the
simplest way to do this of course is
going to be like last week printf
percent s and plug in the S and we're
done but again for the sake of
discussion I forgot about or someone
didn't Implement percent s so how else
could we do this well in pseudo code or
in English like what's the gist of how
we could solve this problem printing out
the string s on the screen without using
percent s
how might we go about
solving this just in English high level
what would your pseudo code look like
yeah
[Music]
okay so just print each letter and maybe
more precisely like some kind of loop
like let's iterate over all of the
characters in s and print one at a time
so how can I do that well for ins I get
zero is kind of the go-to starting point
for most Loops I is less than okay how
long do I want to iterate well it's
going to depend on what I type in but
that's why we have Sterling now so
iterate up to the length of s and then
increment I with plus plus on each
iteration and then let's just print out
percent C with no new line because I
want everything on the same line uh
whatever the character is at s bracket I
and then at the very end I'll give
myself that new line just to move the
cursor down to the next line so the
dollar sign is not in a weird place all
right so let's see if I didn't screw up
any of the code make a string enter so
far so good string and let me type in
something like hi enter and I see output
of high two let me do it once more with
Buy enter and that works too note this I
very deliberately and quickly gave
myself two spaces here and one space
here just because I literally wanted
these things to line up properly and
input is shorter than output but that
was just a deliberate formatting detail
so this code is correct which is a claim
I've made before but it's not well
designed
now
it's It is Well designed and then I'm
using someone else's Library function
like I've not reinvented a wheel there's
no line 15 or below I didn't Implement
string length myself
so I'm at least kind of practicing what
I've preached
but there's still an imperfection a
sub-optimality this one's really subtle
though
and you have to think about how loops
work
what am I doing that's not
super efficient yeah and back
yeah this is a little subtle but if you
think back to the basic definition of a
for Loop and recall when I highlighted
things last week what happens well the
first thing is that oh I get set to zero
then we check the condition how do we
check the condition we call Sterling on
S we get back an answer like three if
it's h i exclamation point and zero is
less than three so that's fine and then
we print out the character then we
increment I from zero to one we recheck
the condition how do I recheck the
condition I call Sterling of s get back
the same answer three compare three
against one we're still good so we print
out another character I gets incremented
again I is now two we check the
condition what's the condition well
what's the string like the best it's
still three two is still less than
three so I keep asking the same question
sort of stupidly because the string is
presumably never changing in length and
indeed every time I check that condition
that function is going to get called and
every time the answer for high is going
to be three three
so it's a marginal sort of
sub-optimality but I I could do better
right like don't ask multiple times
questions that you can remember the
answer to so how could I remember the
answer to this question and ask it just
once
how could I remember the answer to this
question
let me say yeah back there
so stored in a variable right that's
been our answer most any time we want to
keep something around so how could I do
this well I could do something like this
into maybe length equals Sterling of s
then I can just change this function
call so to speak and let me re-fix my
spelling here let me fix this to be now
comparing against length and this is now
okay because now Sterling is only called
once on line nine and I'm reusing the
value of that variable AKA length again
and again and again so that's more
efficient turns out that for Loops
actually let you declare multiple
variables at once so we can actually do
this a little more elegantly all in one
line and this is just now some syntactic
improvement I could actually do
something like this n equals Sterling of
s
and then I could just say n here or I
could call it length but heck while I'm
being succinct I'm just going to use n
for number so now it's just a marginal
change but I've now declared two
variables inside of my loop I and N is
set to 0 and is thanks to the string
length of s but now Hereafter all of my
condition checks are just I less than n
i less than n and n is never now
changing all right so a marginal
Improvement there now that I've used
this new function let's use some other
functions that might be of interest let
me go ahead and write a quick program
here that may be like upper capitalizes
the beginning of uh that changes to
uppercase some string that the user
types in so let me go ahead and code a
file called uppercase.c up here I'll use
my new friends cs50.h and standard i o
and
string.h so standard i o and string.ace
so just as before int main void and then
inside of main what I'm going to do this
time is let's ask the user for a string
s using get string asking them for the
before value
and then let me go ahead and just print
out something like after uh
so that it uh just so I can see what the
uppercase version thereof is and then
after this let me go ahead and do the
following for INT I equals zero oh let's
practice that same lesson so n equals
the string length of s i is less than n
i plus plus so really nothing new really
fundamentally yet
how do I now convert characters from
lowercase if they are to uppercase in
other words if I type in high h i and
lowercase I want my program now to
uppercase everything to capital h
capital i
well how can I go about
doing this well you might recall that
there is this you might recall that
there is this ASCII chart so let's just
consult this real quick on the
asciiart.com we've looked at this last
week notice that a capital A is 65
capital B is 66 Capital C is 67 and heck
here's lowercase a lowercase b lowercase
C and that's 97 98.99 and if I actually
do some math there's like a distance of
32 right so if I want to go from
uppercase to lowercase I can do 65 plus
32 will give me 97 and that actually
works out across the board for
everything else 66 plus 32 gets me to 98
or lowercase b or conversely if you have
a lowercase a and its value is 97
subtract 32 and boom you have capital A
so all right there's some arithmetic
here involved but now that we know that
strings are just arrays and we know that
characters which are in those arrays are
just binary representations of numbers I
think we can manipulate a few of these
things as follows let me go back to my
program here and first ask the question
if the current character in the array
during this Loop is lowercase let's
force it to uppercase
so how am I going to do that if the
character at s bracket I the current
location in the array
is greater than or equal to lowercase A
and S bracket I is less than or equal to
lowercase z kind of a weird con Boolean
expression but completely legitimate
because in this array s is a whole bunch
of characters that the humans typed in
because that's what a string is greater
than or equal to a might be a little
nonsensical because when have you ever
compared numbers to letters but we know
from week zero lowercase a is 97
lowercase z is what is it one I don't
even remember
what's that
132 we know and so that would allow us
to answer the question is the current
letter lowercase all right so let me go
ahead here and answer that question if
it is what do I want to print out I
don't want to print out the letter
itself I want to print out the letter
minus 32 right because if it happens to
be a lowercase a 97 97 minus 32 gives me
65 which is uppercase a and I know that
just from having stared at that chart uh
in the past else if the character is not
between little a and big a I'm just
going to print out the character Itself
by printing s bracket I and at the very
end of this I'm going to go ahead and
print out a new line just to move the
cursor to the next line so again it's a
little wordy but this Loop here
which I borrowed from our code
previously just iterates over the string
AKA array character by character through
its length this line 11 here is just
asking the question if that current
character the ith character of s is
greater than or equal to little a and
less than or equal to little Z that is
between 97 and 132 then we're going to
go ahead and force it to
uh uppercase instead all right and let
me go ahead and zoom out here for just a
second
and
sorry I missed both 122 which is what
you might have said there's only 26
letters so 122 is little Z let me go
ahead now and compile and run this
program so make uppercase
dot slash uppercase and let me type in
high and lowercase enter and there's the
capitalized version thereof let me do it
again with like my own name and
lowercase and now it's capitalized as
well well what could we do to improve
this well you know what let's stop
Reinventing Wheels let's go to the
manual pages so let me go here and
search for something like uh I don't
know lowercase and there I go I did some
autocomplete here our little search box
is saying that okay there's an is lower
function check whether a character is
lowercase well how do I use this well
let me check is lower now I see the
actual man page for this function now we
see include C type dot h so that's the
Proto that's the header file I need to
include this is the prototype for is
lower it apparently takes a Char as
input and returns an INT which is a
little weird I feel like is lower should
return true or false so let's scroll
down to the description and return value
it returns oh this is interesting and
this is a convention in C this function
returns a non-zero int if C is a
lowercase letter and zero if C is not a
lowercase letter so it returns non-zero
so like one negative one something
that's not zero if C is a lowercase
letter and zero if it is not a lowercase
letter so how can we use this building
block let me go back to my code here
let me add this file include C type dot
h and down here let me get rid of this
cryptic expression which was kind of you
know painful to come up with and just
ask this is lower s bracket I
uh
that should actually work
but why well is lower again returns a
non-zero value if the letter is
lowercase well what does that mean that
means it could return one it could
return negative one it could return 50
or negative 50. it's actually not
precisely defined why just because like
this was a common convention to use zero
to represent false and use any other
value to represent true and so it turns
out that inside of Boolean Expressions
if you put a value like a function call
like this that returns zero that's going
to be equivalent to false it's like the
answer being no it is not lower but you
can also just in parentheses put the
name of the function and its argument
and not compare it against anything
because we could do something like this
well if it's not equal to zero then it
must be lowercase because that's the
definition if it returns a non-zero
value it's lowercase but a more succinct
way to do that is just a bit more like
English if it's is lower then print out
the character minus 32 so this would be
the common way of using one of these is
functions to check if the answer is true
or false
okay well we might be done okay
[Music]
no so it's not necessarily one it would
be incorrect to check for one or
negative one or anything else you want
to check for the opposite of zero so not
equal zero or more succinctly like I did
by just putting it into parentheses
let me see what happens here
so this is great but some of you might
have spotted a better solution to this
problem a moment ago when we were on the
manual pages searching for things
related to lowercase what might be
another building block we can employ
here
based on what's on the screen here yeah
so two upper there's a function that
would literally do the upper casing for
me so I don't have to get into the weeds
of like negative 32 plus 32 I don't have
to consult that chart someone has solved
this problem for me in the past
and let's see if I can actually get back
to it
there we go let me go ahead now and use
this so instead of doing s bracket I
minus 32 let's use a function that
someone else wrote and just say two
upper s bracket I and now it's going to
do the pro the solution for me so if I
rerun make uppercase and then do
slowly dot uppercase type in high now
it's working as expected and honestly if
I read the documentation for two upper
by actually going back to its man page
or manual page what you'll see is that
it says if it's lowercase it will return
the uppercase version thereof if it's
not lowercase it's already uppercase
it's punctuation it will just return the
original character which means thanks to
this function I can actually tighten
this up significantly get rid of all of
my conditional there and just print out
the two upper return value and leave it
to whoever wrote that function to figure
out if something's uppercase or
lowercase
all right questions on
these kinds of Tricks again it all
reduces to like week zero Basics but
we're just building these abstractions
on top yeah
[Music]
yes unfortunately no there is no easy
way in C to say give me everything that
was for historically uh performance
reasons they want you to be explicit as
to what you want to include in other
languages like python Java one of which
we'll see later this term you can say
give me everything but that actually
tends to be best practice because it can
actually slow down execution or
compilation of your code yeah
[Music]
ah does two upper accommodate special
characters like punctuation yes if I
read the documentation more pedantically
we would see exactly that it will
properly hand me back an exclamation
point even if I passed it in so if I do
make uppercase here and let me do dot
slash upper sorry a DOT slash uppercase
high with an exclamation point it's
going to handle that too and just pass
it through unchanged yeah
[Music]
all of that
just bring it rather
Administration really good question too
no we do not have access to a function
that at least comes with C or comes with
cs50s library that will just force the
whole thing to uppercase in C that's
actually easier said than done in Python
it's trivial so stay tuned for another
language what that will let us do
exactly that
all right so what does this leave us
with there's just a let's come full
circle now to where we began today where
we were talking about those command line
arguments recall that we talked about RM
taking a command line argument the word
the file you want to delete we talked
about clang taking command line
arguments that again modify the behavior
of the program how is it that maybe you
and I can start to write programs that
actually take command line arguments
well here is where I can finally explain
why we've been typing int main void for
the past week and just asking that you
take on faith that it's just the way you
do things well by default in C at least
the most late the most uh recent
versions thereof there's only two
official ways to write main functions
you might see other formats online but
they're generally not consistent with
the current specification this again was
sort of the boilerplate for the simplest
function we might write last week and
recall that we've been doing this the
whole time void what that void means for
all the programs I have written thus far
and you have written thus far is that
none of our programs that we've written
take command line arguments that's what
the void there means it turns out that
main is the way you can specify that
your program does in fact take command
line arguments that is words after the
command in your terminal window if you
want to actually not use get int or get
string you want the human to be able to
say something like hello David and hit
enter and just run hello print hello
David on the screen you can use command
line arguments words after the program
name on your command line so we're going
to change this in a moment to be
something more verbose but something
that's now a bit more familiar
syntactically if you change that void in
main to be this incantation instead int
rxc comma string ARG V Open Bracket
close bracket you are now giving
yourself access to writing programs that
take command line arguments ARG C which
stands for argument count is going to be
an integer that stores how many words
the human typed at the prompt we the C
automatically gives that to you
string ARG v stands for argument Vector
that's going to be an array of all of
the words that the human typed at the
prompt so with today's building block of
an array we have the ability now to let
the humans type as many words or as few
words as they want at the prompt C is
going to automatically put them in an
array called ARG V and it's going to
tell us how many words there are in an
ant called ARG C
the int as the return type here we'll
come back to in just a moment let's
actually use now this definition to make
maybe just a couple of simple programs
but in problem set 2 will we actually
use this to control the behavior of your
own code let me go ahead and code up a
file called
argv.0 just to keep its uh aptly named
let me go ahead and include cs50.h let
me go ahead and include whoops that is
not the right name of a program let's
start that over
let's go ahead and code up arcv.c
and here we have uh include cs50.h
includes standardio.h int main not void
let's actually say int rxc
string ARG V Open Bracket close bracket
no numbers in between because you don't
know in advance how many words the
human's going to type at their prompt
now let's go ahead and do this let's
write a very simple program that just
says hello David hello Carter whoever
the name is that gets typed but not
using get string let's instead have the
human just type their name at the prompt
just like RM just like clang just like
make so it's just one and done when you
hit enter no additional prompts let me
go ahead then and do this printf quote
unquote hello comma and instead of world
today I want to print out whatever the
human typed in so let's go ahead and do
this ARG V bracket zero for now
but I don't think this is quite what I
want
because of course that's going to
literally print out argv bracket zero
bracket then I need a placeholder so let
me put a percent s here and then put
that here
so if ARG V is an array but it's an
array of strings then ARG V bracket zero
is itself a single string and so it can
be plugged into that percent s
placeholder let me go ahead and save my
program
and let me go ahead and compile ARG V so
far so good let me go ahead now and type
in my name after the name of the program
so no get string I'm literally typing an
extra word my own name at the prompt
enter
okay it's it's apparently a little buggy
in a couple of ways I forgot my
backslash n but that's not a huge deal
but apparently inside of argv is
literally everything the humans typed in
including the name of the program so
logically how do I print out hello David
or hello so and so and not the actual
name of the program what needs to change
here yeah
yeah so presumably index to one if
that's the second thing I or who
whichever human has typed at the prompt
so let's do make arcv again dot slash
ARG V enter
huh hello null so this is another form
of null but this is user error now on my
part
I didn't do exactly what I said I would
yeah
yeah I forgot the parameter so that's
actually I should probably deal with
that somehow so that people aren't sort
of breaking my program and printing out
random things like no but if I do say
argue David now you see hello David I
can get a little curious like what's at
location two well we can see make ARG V
bracket dot slash RV David enter all
right so just nothing is there but it
turns out in a couple weeks we'll start
really poking around memory and see if
we can't crash programs deliberately
because nothing is technically stopping
me from saying oh what's that location 2
million for instance we could really
start to get curious but for now we'll
do the right thing but let's now make
sure the human has typed in the right
number of words so let's say this if ARG
C equals 2 that is the name of the
program and one more word after that go
ahead and trust that an rv1 as you
proposed is the person's name else let's
go ahead and just default here to
something simple and basic like well if
we don't get a name from the user just
say hello world like always
so now we're sort of programming
defensively this time the human even if
they screw up they don't give us a name
or they give us too many names we're
just going to say hello world because I
now have some error handling here
because again ARG C is argument count
the number of words total typed at the
command line so make arc V
dot slash Arc vein let me make the same
mistake as before okay I don't get this
weird null Behavior I get something well
defined I could now do David I could do
David Malin but that's not currently
supported I would need to alter my logic
to support more than just two words
after the prompt so what's the point of
this at the moment it's just a simple
exercise to actually
then they run the program
consider it's just more convenient in
this new command line interface world if
you had to use get string every time you
compile your code it'd be kind of
annoying right you type make then you
might get a prompt what would you like
to make then you type in hello or cash
or something else then you hit enter it
just really slows the process but in
this command line interface world if you
support command line arguments then you
can use these little tricks like
scrolling up and down in your history
with your arrow keys you can just type
commands more quickly because you can do
it all once all at once and you don't
have to keep prompting the user more
pedantically for more and more info
so any questions then on command line
arguments which finally reveals why we
had void initially but what more we can
now put in main that's how you take
command line arguments yeah
[Music]
yes if you were to type at the command
line something like not a a word but
something like the number 42 that would
actually be treated as a string why
because again context matters so if your
program is currently manipulating memory
as though it's characters or strings
whatever those patterns of zeros and
ones are they will be interpreted as
ASCII text or Unicode text if we
therefore go to the Chart here that
might make you wonder well then how do
you distinguish numbers from letters in
the context of something like chars and
strings well notice 65 is a 97 is a but
also 49 is one and 50 is 2. so the
designers of ASCII and then later
Unicode realized well wait a minute if
we want to support programs that let you
type things that look like numbers even
though they're not technically ins or
floats we need a way in ASCII and
unicode to represent even numbers so
here are your numbers and it's a little
silly that we have numbers representing
other numbers but again if you're in the
world of letters and characters you
gotta come up with a mapping for
everything and notice here here's the
dot even if you were to represent 1.23
as a string or as characters even the
dot now is going to be represented as an
ASCII character so again context here
matters all right one final example to
tease apart what this int is and what
it's been doing here for so long so I'm
going to go ahead and add one bit of
logic here to a new file that I'm going
to call exit dot C so in exit.c we're
going to introduce that something that
are generally known as exit status it
turns out this is not a feature we've
used yet but it's just useful to know
about especially when automating tests
of your own code when it comes to
figuring out if a program succeeded or
failed it turns out that main has one
more feature we haven't leveraged an
ability to signal to the user whether
something was successful or not and
that's by way of Maine's return value so
I'm going to go ahead and now modify
this program as follows like this
suppose I want to write a similar
program that requires that the user type
a Word at the prompt so that rxc has to
be 2 for whatever design purpose if rxc
does not equal 2 I want to quit out of
my program prematurely because I want to
just insist that the user operate the
program correctly so I might give them
an error message like missing command
line argument backslash n but now I want
to quit out of the program now how can I
do that the right way quote unquote to
do that is to return a value from Main
now it's a little weird because no one
called main yet right main just gets
called automatically but the convention
is anytime something goes wrong in a
program you should return a non-zero
value from Maine one is fine as a go-to
we don't need to get into the weeds of
having many different exit statuses so
to speak but if you return one that is a
clue to the system the Mac the PC the
cloud device that something went wrong
why because one is not zero
if everything works fine like let's go
ahead and print out hello comma percent
s like before uh quote unquote ardv
bracket one
so this is just a version of the program
without an else so this is the same as
doing essentially an else here like I
did earlier I want to signal to the
computer that all is well and so I
return zero but strictly speaking if I'm
already returning here I don't
technically need if I really want to be
nitpicky I don't technically need the
else because the only way I'm going to
get to line 11 is if I didn't already
return so what's going on here the only
new thing here logically is that for the
first time ever I'm returning a value
from Main that's something I could
always have done because Maine has
always been defined by us as taking an
INT as a return value
by default main automatically sort of
secretly returns zero for you if you've
never once used the return keyword which
you probably haven't in main it just
automatically returns zero and the
system assumes that all went well but
now that we're starting to get a little
more sophisticated with our code and you
know the programmer something went wrong
you can abort programs early you can
exit out of them by returning some other
value besides xero from Main and this is
sort of fortuitous that it's an INT
right zero means everything worked
unfortunately in programming there are
seemingly an infinite number of things
that can go wrong and ants gives you
four billion possible codes that you can
use AKA exit statuses to signify errors
so if you've ever on your Mac or PC
gotten some weird pop-up that an error
happened sometimes there's a cryptic
number in it maybe it's positive maybe
it's negative it might say error code
123 or negative 49 or something like
that what you're generally seeing are
these exit statuses these return values
for Main in a program that someone at
Microsoft or apple or somewhere else
wrote something went wrong they are sort
of unnecessarily showing you the user
what the error code is if only so that
when you call customer support or submit
a ticket you can tell them what exit
status you encountered what error code
you encounter
all right any questions then on exit
statuses which is the last of our new
building blocks
for now
any questions at all yeah
foreign
[Music]
you do things again and again at the
command line like you could with get
string and get in which by default
recall are automatically designed to
keep prompting the user in their own
Loop until they give you a stint or a
float or the like with command line
arguments no you're going to get an
error message but then you're going to
be returned to your prompt and it's up
to you to type it correctly the next
time
good question yeah
[Music]
if you do not return a value explicitly
Maine will automatically return zero for
you like that is the way C simply works
so it's not strictly necessary but now
that we're starting to return values
explicitly if something goes wrong it
would be good practice to also start
returning a value for main when
something goes right and there are no
errors in fact
so let's now get out of the weeds and
contextualize this for some actual
problems that we'll be solving in the
coming Days by way of problem set two
and Beyond so here for instance
so here for instance is a problem that
you might think back to when you were a
kid the the readability of some text or
some book the grade level in which some
book is written if you're a young
student you might read at a first grade
level or third grade level in the U.S or
if you're in college presumably you're
reading at a university level of text
but what does it mean for text like in a
book or in an essay or something like
that to correspond to some kind of grade
level well here's a quote a title of a a
childhood book One Fish Two Fish Redfish
Bluefish
what might the grade level be for a book
that has words like this maybe when you
were a kid or if you have a sibling
still reading these things what might
the grade level of this thing be
[Music]
any guesses yeah
sorry again
before grade one is in fact correct so
that's for really young kids and and why
is that well let's consider these are
actually pretty simple phrases Right One
Fish Two Fish Red I mean there's not
even verbs in these sentences they're
just uh nouns and adjectives and very
short sentences and so that might be a
heuristic we could use when analyzing
text well if the words are kind of short
the sentences are kind of short
everything's very simple that's probably
a very young or early grade level and so
by one formulation it might indeed be
even before grade one for someone quite
young how about this Mr and Mrs dursley
of number four privet Drive we're proud
to say that they were perfectly normal
thank you very much they were the last
people you would expect to be involved
in anything strange or mysterious
because they just didn't hold with such
nonsense and onward all right what grade
level is this book at
okay I heard third
seventh fifth okay all over the place
but grade seven according to one
particular measure and whether or not we
can we can debate exactly what age you
were when you read this and maybe you're
feeling ahead of your time or behind now
but here
we have a snippet of text what makes
this text assume an older audience a
more mature audience a higher grade
level would you think
yeah it's longer different types of
words there's commas now and phrases and
so forth so there's just some kind of
sophistication to this so it turns out
for the upcoming problem set among the
things you'll do is take as input texts
like this and analyze them considering
well how many words are in the text how
many sentences are in the text how many
letters are in the text and use those
according to a well-defined formula to
prescribe what exactly the grade level
of some actual text there's the third
might actually be well what else are we
going to do in the coming days well I've
alluded to this notion of cryptography
in the past this notion of scrambling
information in such a way that you can
hide the contents of a message from
someone who might otherwise intercept it
right the earliest form of this might
also be when you're younger and you're
in class and you're passing a note from
one person to another from yourself to
someone else you don't want to just
necessarily write a note in English or
some other written language you might
want to scramble it somehow or encrypt
it maybe you change the A's to a b and
the B's to a c so that if the teacher
snaps it up and intercepts it they can't
actually understand what it is you've
written because it's encrypted now so
long as your friend the recipient of
this note knows how you manipulated it
how you added or subtracted sort of
letters to each other they can decrypt
it which is to say reverse that process
so formally in the world of cryptography
and computer science this is just
another problem to solve your input
though when you have a message you want
to send securely is what's generally
known as plain text there's some
algorithm that's going to then encipher
or encrypt that information into what's
called ciphertext which is The Scrambled
version that theoretically can get
safely intercepted and your message has
not been spoiled unless that intercept
actually knows what algorithm you used
inside of this process so that that
would be generally known as a cipher the
ciphers typically take though not one
input but two if for instance your
Cipher is as simple as a becomes b b
becomes c c becomes D dot dot Z becomes
a you're essentially adding one one to
every letter and encrypting it now that
would be what we call the key you and
the recipient both have to agree
presumably before class in advance what
number you're going to use that day to
rotate or change all of these letters by
because when you add one they upon
receiving your ciphertext have to
subtract one to get back the answer so
for instance if the input plain text is
high as before and the key is one the
cipher text using this simple rotational
algorithm otherwise known as the Caesar
Cipher might be IJ exclamation point so
it's similar but it's at least scrambled
at first glance and unless the teacher
really cares to figure out what
algorithm are they using today or what
key are they using today it's probably
sufficiently secure for your purposes
how do you reverse the process while
your friend gets this and reverses it by
negative one so I becomes h j becomes I
and things like punctuation remain
untouched at least in this scheme so
let's consider one final example here if
the input
to the algorithm is uijt xbt dt50 and
the key this time is negative one such
that now B should become a and C should
become b and a should become Z so we're
going in the other direction how might
we analyze this well if we spread all
the letters out and we start from left
to right and we start subtracting one
letter U becomes t i becomes h j becomes
i t becomes s x becomes w a was d t this
was cs50 we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50 and this is already week
three and even as we've gotten much more
into the minutia of programming and some
of the sea stuff that we've been doing
is all the more cryptic looking recall
that at the end of the day like
everything we've been doing ultimately
fits into to this model so keep that in
mind particularly as things seem like
they're getting more complicated more
sophisticated it's just a process of
learning a new language that ultimately
lets us express this process and of
course last week we really went into the
weeds of like how inputs and outputs are
represented and this thing here a
photograph thereof is called what
this is what
Ram I heard random access memory or just
generally known as memory and recall
that we looked at one of these little
black chips that that contains all of
the bytes all of the bits ultimately
it's just kind of a grid sort of an
artist's grid that allows us to think
about every one of these memory
locations is just having a number or an
address so to speak like this might be
byte number zero and then one and then
two and then maybe way down here again
something like two billion if you have
two gigabytes of memory and so as we did
that we started to explore how we could
use this canvas to create kind of our
own information our own inputs and
outputs not just the basics like ants
and floats and so forth but we also
talked about strings and what is a
string as you now know it how would you
describe in layperson's terms a string
yeah over there
an array of characters and an array
meanwhile let's go there how might
someone else Define an array in more
familiar now terms what would be an
array
[Music]
an indexed set of things not bad and I
think a key characteristic to keep in
mind with an array is that it does
actually pertain to memory and it's
contiguous memory byte after byte after
bite is what constitutes an array and
we'll see in a couple of weeks time that
there's actually more interesting ways
to use this same primitive canvas to
stitch together things that are sort of
two-directional even that have some kind
of shape to them but for now all we've
talked about is arrays and just using
these things from left to right top to
bottom continuously to represent
information so today we'll consider
still an array but we won't focus so
much on representation of strings or
other data types we'll actually now
focus on the other part of that process
of inputs becoming outputs namely the
thing in the middle uh algorithms but we
have to keep in mind even though every
time we've looked at an array thus far
certainly on the board like this you as
a human certainly have the luxury of
just kind of eyeballing the whole thing
with the bird's eye view and seeing
where all of those numbers are if I ask
you where a particular number is like
zero odds are your eyes would go right
to where it is and boom problem solved
in sort of one step but the catch is
with a computer that has this memory
even though you the human can corner see
everything at once a computer cannot
it's better to think of your computer's
memory your phone's memory or more
specifically an array of memory like
this as really being a set of closed
doors not unlike Lockers in a school and
only by opening each of those doors can
the computer actually see what's in
there which is to say that the computer
unlike you doesn't have this bird's eye
view of all of the data in all these
locations it has to much more
methodically look here maybe look here
maybe look here and so forth in order to
find something now fortunately we
already have some building blocks Loops
conditions Boolean expressions and the
like where you could imagine writing
some code that very methodically goes
from left to right or right to left or
something more sophisticated that
actually finds something you're looking
for and just remember that the
convention we've had since last week now
is that these arrays are zero indexed so
to speak to be zero index just means
that the data type starts counting from
zero so this is location zero one two
three four five six and notice even
though there are seven total doors here
the rightmost one of course is called
six just because we've started counting
it zero so in the general case if you
had n doors or n bytes of memory zero
would always be at the left and N minus
one would always be at the right that's
sort of a generalization of just
thinking about this kind of convention
all right so let's revisit the problem
that we started the whole term off with
in week one week zero which was this
notion of searching and what does it
mean to search for something well to
find information and this of course is
omnipresent anytime you take out your
phone you're searching for a friend's
contact anytime you pull up a browser
you're Googling for this or that so
search is kind of one of the most
omnipresent topics and features of any
device these days so let's consider how
the Googles the apples the microsofts of
the world are implementing something as
seemingly familiar as this so here might
be the problem statement we want some
input to become some output what's that
input going to be maybe it's a bunch of
closed doors like this out of which we
want to get back and answer true or
false is something we're looking for
there or not you could imagine taking
this one step further and trying to find
where is the thing you're looking for
but for now let's just take one bite out
of the problem can we tell ourselves
true or false is some number behind one
of these doors or Lockers in memory but
before we go there and start talking
about ways to do that that is algorithms
let's consider how we might lay the
foundation of like comparing whether one
algorithm is better than another we
talked about correctness and it sort of
goes without saying that any code you
write any algorithm you implement had
better be correct otherwise what's the
point if it doesn't give you the right
answers but we also talked about design
and in your own words like what do we
mean when we say a program is better
designed at this stage than another
how do you think about this notion of
design now yeah in the middle
okay so easier to understand I like that
other thoughts yeah
efficiency and what do you mean by
efficiency precisely
[Music]
nice it doesn't use up too much memory
and it isn't redundant so you can think
about design along a few of these axes
sort of the quality of the code but also
the quality of the performance and as
our programs get bigger and more
sophisticated and uh more and just
longer those kinds of things are really
going to matter and in the real world if
you start writing code not just by
yourself but with someone else getting
the design right is just going to make
it easier to collaborate and ultimately
produce right code with just higher
probability so let's consider how we
might focus on exactly the second
characteristic the efficiency of an
algorithm and the way we might talk
about the efficiency of algorithms just
how fast or how slow they are is in
terms of their running time that is to
say when they're running how much time
do they take and we might measure this
in seconds or milliseconds or minutes or
just some number of steps in the general
case because presumably fewer steps to
your point is better than more steps so
how might we think about running times
well there's one General notation we
should Define today so computer
scientists tend to describe the running
time of an algorithm or a piece of code
for that matter in terms of what's
called Big O notation this is literally
a capitalized O A Big O and this
generally means that the running time of
some algorithm is on the order of such
and such where such and such we'll see
is just going to be a very simple
mathematical formula it's kind of a way
of waving your hands mathematically to
convey the idea of just how fast or how
slow some algorithm or code is without
getting into the weeds of like it took
this many milliseconds or this many
specific number of steps so you might
recall then from week zero I even
introduced this picture but without much
context at the time we just use this to
compare those phone book algorithms
recall that this red straight line was
the first algorithm one page at a time
the yellow line that's still straight
different how if you recall
that line represented What alternative
algorithm
[Music]
looking out and back what is that second
algorithm yeah over there
two pages at a time which was almost
correct so long as we potentially double
back a page if maybe we go a little too
far in the phone book so it had a
potential bug but arguably solvable this
last algorithm though was the so-called
divide and conquer strategy where I sort
of unnecessarily tore the phone book in
half and then in half and then in half
which dramatic as that was unnecessarily
it actually took significantly bigger
bites out of the problem like 500 pages
the first time another 250 another 125
versus just one or two bytes at a time
and so we described its running time as
this picture there though I didn't use
that expression at the time running
times but indeed time to solve might be
measured just abstractly in some unit of
measure seconds milliseconds minutes
Pages via this y-axis here so let's now
slap some numbers on this if we had n
pages in that phone book and just
representing a generic number the first
algorithm here we might describe as
taking end steps second algorithm we
might describe as taking n divided by
two steps maybe give or take one if we
have to double back but generally n
divided by two and then this thing if
you remember your logarithms was sort of
a fundamentally different formula log
base 2 of n or just log of n for short
so this is sort of a fundamentally
different formula but what's noteworthy
is that these first two algorithms even
though yes the second algorithm was
hands down faster I mean literally twice
as fast when you start to zoom out and
if I increase my y-axis and x-axis these
first two whoops
these first two start to look awfully
similar to one another and if we keep
zooming out zooming out zooming out as n
gets really large that is the x-axis
gets really long these first two
algorithms start to become essentially
the same and so this is where computer
scientists use Big O notation instead of
saying specifically this algorithm takes
n steps and this one n divided by two a
computer scientist would say ah each of
those algorithms takes on the order of n
steps or on the order of n over two but
you know what on the order of n over 2
is pretty much the same when n gets
really large as being equivalent to Big
O of n itself so yes in practice it's
obviously fewer steps to move twice as
fast but in the big picture when n
becomes a million a billion the numbers
are already so darn big at that point
that these are as the shapes of these
curves imply pretty much functionally
equivalent but this one still looks
better in bed better is and gets large
because it's rising so much less quickly
and so here a computer scientist would
say that that third algorithm was on the
order of that is Big O of log n and you
don't have to bother with the base
because it's a smaller mathematical
detail that is also just in some sense a
constant multiplicative Factor so in
short what are the takeaways here this
is just a new vocabulary that we'll
start to use when we just want to
describe the running time of an
algorithm to make this more real if any
of you have implemented a for loop at
this point in any of your code and that
for Loop iterated n times where maybe n
was the height of your pyramid or maybe
n was something else that you wanted to
do n times you wrote code or you
implemented an algorithm that operated
in Big O of n time if you will so this
is just a way now to retroactively start
describing with somewhat mathematical
notation what we've been doing in
practice for a while now so here's a
list of commonly
seen running times in the real world
this is not a thorough list because you
could come up with an infinite number of
mathematical formulas certainly but the
common ones we'll discuss and you will
see in your own code probably reduced to
this list here and if you were to study
more computer science theory this list
would get longer and longer but for now
these are sort of the most familiar ones
that we'll soon save all right two other
pieces of vocabulary if you will before
we start to use this stuff so this a big
Omega Capital omega symbol is used now
to describe a lower bound on the running
time of an algorithm so to be clear Big
O is on the order of that is an upper
bound on how many steps an algorithm
might take on the order of so many steps
if you want to talk though from the
other perspective well how few steps
might my algorithm take maybe in the
so-called best case it'd be nice if we
had a notation to just describe what a
lower bound is because some algorithms
might be super fast in these so-called
best cases so the symbology is almost
the same but we replace the Big O with
the big Omega so to be clear Big O
describes an upper bound and Omega
describes a lower bound and we'll see
examples of this before long and then
lastly last one here big Theta is used
by a computer scientist when you have a
case where both the upper bound on an
algorithm's running time is the same as
the lower bound you can then describe it
in one breath as being in Theta of such
and such instead of saying it's in Big O
and in Omega of something else
all right so out of context sort of just
sort of um seemingly cryptic symbols but
all they refer to is upper bound lower
bounds or when they happen to be one and
the same and we'll now introduce over
time examples of how we might actually
apply these to concrete problems but
first let me pause
to see if there's any questions
any questions here
any questions
I see pointing somewhere uh where are
you pointing to
over here there we go okay sorry very
bright
[Music]
smaller end functions move faster so yes
if you have something like n that takes
only n steps if you have a formula like
N squared just by nature of the math
that would take more steps and therefore
be slower so the larger the mathematical
expression the slower your algorithm is
because the more time or more steps that
it takes
you want your end function so to speak
to be small yes and in fact the Holy
Grail so to speak would be this last one
here either in Big O notation or even
Theta when an algorithm is on the order
of a single step that means it literally
takes constant time one step or maybe 10
steps 100 steps but a fixed constant
number of steps that's the best because
even as the phone book gets bigger even
as the data set you're searching gets
larger and larger if something only
takes a finite number of steps
constantly then it doesn't matter how
big the data set actually gets
questions as well on these notations yep
thank you for the pointing this is
actually very helpful I'm seeing
pointing this way
[Music]
what is the input to each of these
functions it is an expression of how
many steps an algorithm takes so in fact
let me go ahead and make this more
concrete with an actual example here if
we could so on stage here we have seven
lockers which represent if you will an
array of memory and this array of memory
is maybe storing seven integers seven
integers that we might actually want to
search for and if we want to search for
these values how might we go about doing
this well for this why don't we make
things interesting would a volunteer
like to come on up have to be masked and
on the internet if you are comfortable
both of those or someone putting their
friend's hand up and back yes okay come
on down
[Music]
and in just a moment our brave volunteer
is going to help me find a specific
number in the data set that we have here
on the screen so come on down and I'll
get things ready for you in advance here
come on down
[Music]
nice to meet and what is your name
nice to meet you come on over so here we
have for namira uh seven lockers or an
array of memory and behind each of these
doors is a number and the goal quite
simply is given this array of memory as
input to return true or false is the
number I care about actually there so
suppose I care about the number zero
what would be the simplest most correct
algorithm you could apply in order to
find us the number zero
[Music]
okay try open the first one
all right and just maybe just step aside
so the audience can see I think you have
not found xero yet okay so keep the door
open let's move on to your next choice
second door sure
oh go ahead second door well let's keep
it simple let's just move from left to
right sort of searching our way and what
do you see there up six not zero how
about the next door
[Music]
all right it's also not working out so
well yet but that's okay if you want to
go on to the next we're still looking
for zero
all right I see a two all right it's not
so good yet let's keep going next door
two seven no okay next door
no that's uh all right very well done
all right so I kind of set you up for a
fairly slow algorithm but let me just
ask you to describe what is it you did
by following the steps I gave you
you went one by one to each character
and if you want to talk into here
so you went one by one by each character
and would you say that algorithm left to
right is correct
no no
yes in the scenario okay yes and this is
an area and why are you hesitating
because it's not the most efficient way
to do it okay good so we see a contrast
here between correctness and design I
mean I do think it was correct because
even though it was slow you eventually
found zero but it took some number of
steps so in fact this would be an
algorithm it has a name called linear
search and the mirror as you did you
kind of walked along a line going from
left to right now let me ask if you had
gone from right to left would the
algorithm have been fundamentally better
[Music]
yes okay and why because the zeros here
and the first scenario but then um if it
was like the zeros in the middle it
wouldn't have been yeah and so here is
sort of where the the right way to do
things becomes a little less obvious you
would absolutely have given yourself a
better result if you would just happen
to start from the right or if I had
pointed you to start over there but the
catch is if I asked her to find another
number like the number eight well that
would have backfired and this time it
would have taken longer to find that
number because it's way over here
instead and so in the general case you
know going left to right or heck right
to left is probably as correct as you
can get because if you know nothing
about the order of these numbers and
indeed they seem to be fairly random
some of them are smaller some of them
are bigger there doesn't seem to be
Rhyme or Reason linear search is about
as as good as you can do when you don't
know anything up priori about the
numbers so I have a little thank you
gifts here a little cs50 stress ball a
round of applause for our first
volunteer
thank you so much
let's try to formalize what I just
described as linear search because
indeed no matter which end the mirror
had started on I could have kind of
changed up the problem to make sure that
it appears to be running slow but it is
correct if zero were among those doors
he absolutely would have found it and
indeed did so let's now try to translate
what we did into what we might call
again pseudocode as from week zero so
with pseudo code we just need a terse
English like or any language syntax to
describe what we did so here might be
one formulation of what Amira did for
each door from left to right if the
number is behind the door return true
else at the very end of the program you
would return false by default and now
you got lucky and by the seventh door
namira had indeed returned True by
saying well there is the zero
but let's consider if this pseudo code
is now correct an accurate translation
first of all normally when we've seen
ifs we might see an if else and yet down
here return false is aligned with the
four
why did I not indent the return false or
put another way why did I not do if
number is behind door return true else
returned false
why would that version of this code have
been problematic way and back
[Music]
okay I'm not sure it's because of
redundancy let me go ahead and just make
this explicit if I had instead done else
return false I don't think it's so much
redundancy that I'd be worried about let
me bounce somewhere else yeah in front
[Music]
yeah I would be returning false for uh
even though I'd only looked at her nimir
had only looked at one element and it
would have been as though if all these
doors were still closed she opens this
up and sees nope this is not zero return
false that would give me an incorrect
result because obviously at that stage
in the algorithm she wouldn't have even
looked through any of the other doors so
just the original indentation of this if
you will without the else is correct
because only if I get to the bottom of
this algorithm or this pseudo code does
it make sense to conclude at that point
once she's gone through all of the doors
that nope there's in fact the number the
number I'm looking for is in fact not
actually there so how might we consider
now the running time of this algorithm
we have a few different uh types of
vocabulary now and if we consider now
how we might think about this let's
start to translate it from sort of
higher level pseudocode to something a
little lower level right we've been
writing code using n and loops and the
like so let's take this higher level
pseudocode and now just kind of get a
middle ground between English and C let
me propose that we think about this
version of the same algorithm as being a
little more pedantic for I from 0 to n
minus 1 if number behind doors bracket I
return true otherwise at the end of the
program return false now I'm kind of
mixing English and C here but that's
reasonable if the reader is familiar
with C or some similar language and
notice this pattern here this is a way
of just saying in pseudo code
uh give myself a variable called I start
at zero and then just count up to n
minus one and recall n minus 1 is not
one PSI of the end of the array n minus
1 is the end of the array because again
we started counting at zero so this is a
very common way of expressing this kind
of loop from the left all the way to the
right of an array doors I'm kind of
implicitly treating as the name of this
array like it's a variable from last
week that I defined as being an array of
integers in this case so doors bracket I
means that when I is zero it's this
location when I is 1 it's this when I is
7 or more generally n minus one sorry
six or more generally n minus one that's
this location here so same idea but a
translation of it so now let's consider
what the running time of this algorithm
is if we have this menu of possible
answers to this question how efficient
or inefficient is this algorithm let's
take a look in the context if the pseudo
code we don't even have to bother going
all the way to Sea how do we go about
analyzing each of these steps well let's
consider this this outermost Loop here
for I from 0 to n minus 1 that line of
code is going to execute how many times
how many times will that Loop
execute let me give folks this moment to
think on it
how many times is that going to Loop
here uh yeah over there
[Music]
end times right because it's from 0 to n
minus 1 and if it's a little weird to
think in from zero to n minus one this
is essentially the same mathematically
as from 1 to n and that's perhaps a
little more obviously more intuitively
and total steps so I might just make a
note to myself this Loop is going to
operate n times what about these inner
steps well how many steps or seconds
does it take to ask a question if the
number behind if the number you're
looking for is behind doors bracket I
well as namina did that's kind of like
one step right so you open the door and
boom or maybe it's two steps but it's a
constant number of steps so this is some
constant number of steps let's just call
it one for Simplicity how many steps or
seconds does it take to return true I
don't know exactly in the computer's
memory but that feels like a single step
just return true so if this takes one
step this takes one step but only if the
condition is true it looks like you're
doing a constant number of Things N
times
or maybe you're doing one additional
step
so in short the only thing that really
matters here in terms of their
efficiency or inefficiency of the
algorithm is what are you doing again
and again and again because that's
obviously the thing that's going to add
up doing one thing or two things a
constant number of times not a big deal
but looping that's going to add up over
time because the more doors there are
the more the bigger n is going to be and
the more steps that's going to take
which is all to say if you were to
describe roughly how many steps does
this algorithm take in Big O notation
what might your instincts say
how many steps is this algorithm on the
order of given n doors or n integers
yeah
say again
Big O of N and indeed that's going to be
the case here why because you're
essentially at the end of the day doing
N Things as an upper bound on running
time and that's in fact what exactly
what happens with Amina so you had to
look at all in lockers before finally
getting to the right answer but what if
she got lucky and the number we were
looking for was not at the end of the
array but were was at the beginning of
the array how might we think about that
well we have a nomenclature for this too
of course Omega notation remember Omega
notation is a lower bound so given this
menu of possible running times for lower
bounds on an algorithm what might the
Omega notation be for namina's linear
search
uh Omega of 1 and why that
[Music]
right because if just by chance she gets
lucky and the number she's looking for
is right there where she Begins the
algorithm that's it it's one step maybe
it's two steps if you have to like
unlock the door and open it but it's a
constant number of steps and the way we
describe constant number of steps is
just with a single number like one so
the Omega notation for linear search
might be Omega of one because in the
best case you might just get the number
right from the get-go but in the worst
case we need to talk about the upper
bound which might indeed be Big O of n
so again there's this way now of talking
symbolically about best cases and worst
cases or upper lower bounds and upper
bounds Theta notation just as a little
trivia now is it applicable based on the
definition I gave earlier
okay no because you only take out the
Fado notation when those two bounds
upper and lower happen to be the same
for shorthand notation if you will so it
suffices here to talk about just Big O
and Omega notation well what if we are a
little smarter about this let me go
ahead and sort of semi-secretely here
rearrange these numbers but first how
about one other volunteer one other
volunteer to be comfortable with your
mask and you're being on the internet
how about over here
yes you want to come on down all right
come on down and don't look at what I'm
doing because I'm going to
[Applause]
[Music]
take your time because and don't look up
this way because I need a moment to
rearrange all of the numbers
and actually if you could stay right
there before coming up just an awkward
few seconds while I finish hiding the
numbers Behind These doors for you
I will be right with you
actually if um
do you want to warm up the crowd for a
moment and I'll be right back so you
want to introduce yourself yeah hi guys
I'm rave
[Applause]
all right I think I am ready thank you
for stalling there of course and I
didn't catch your name what was your
name I'm Rave sorry Rave like a party
Rave okay nice to meet you come on over
so Rave is kindly volunteered now and
I'm going to give you an additional
Advantage this time
um unbeknownst to you I now took numbers
behind the doors but I sorted them for
you so they're not in the same random
order like they were for namina you now
have the advantage to know that the
numbers are sorted from small to big
okay given that and given perhaps what
we talked about in week zero with the
phone book where might you propose we
begin the story this time with which
locker
to find zero uh let's find number six
this time let's make things interesting
okay
um I'll start in the middle okay so the
middle there's seven total so that would
be right here go ahead open that up
and you find sadly the number five so
what do you know now
um I know to go up okay yeah okay all
right so and just to keep it uniform
just like I did uh I opened to the right
half of the phone book let's keep it
similar yeah all right all right and uh
a little too far even though I know you
wanted to go one over all good all good
and now we're gonna go which direction
over here in the middle all right and
voila the number six all right so very
nicely done
a little stress ball for you as well
thank you again so here we see by nature
of the locker door still being open sort
of uh an artifact of the greater
efficiency it would seem of this
algorithm because now that
um Rave was given the assumption that
these numbers are sorted from small on
the left to large on the right she was
able to apply that same divide and
conquer algorithm from week zero which
we're now going to give a name binary
search and simply by starting in the
middle and realizing okay too small then
by going to the right half and realizing
oh went a little too far then by going
to the left half which raise Brave able
to find in just three steps instead of
seven the number six in this case that
we were actually searching for so you
can see that this would seem to be more
efficient
let's consider for just a moment is it
correct if I had used different numbers
but still sorted them from left to right
would it still have worked
this algorithm you're nodding your head
can I call on you like why would it
still have worked do you think
[Music]
yeah so so long as the numbers are
always in the same order from left to
right or heck they could even be in
reverse order so long it's it's
consistent the decisions that Rave was
making if greater than else if less than
would guide us to the solution no matter
what and it would seem to take fewer
steps so if we consider now the pseudo
code for this algorithm let's take a
look how we might describe binary search
so binary search we might describe with
something like this if the number is
behind the middle door which is where
Rave began then we can just return true
else if the number is less than the
middle door so if six is less than
whatever's behind the middle door then
Rave would have searched the left half
else if the number is greater than the
middle door Rave would have searched the
right half else
if there are no doors and we'll see in a
moment why I put this up top just to
keep things clean if there's no doors
what should Rave have presumably
returned immediately if I gave her no
lockers to work with
just return false but this is an
important case to consider because if in
the process of searching by Locker by
Locker we might have whittled down the
problem from seven doors to three doors
to one door to zero doors and at that
point we might have had no doors left to
search so we have to naturally have a
scenario for just considering if there
were no doors so it's not to say that
maybe I don't give Rave any doors to
begin with but as she divides and
divides and divides if she runs out of
lockers to ask those questions of or a
few weeks ago if I ran out of phone book
pages to Taryn half I too might have had
to return false as in this case so how
can we now describe this a little more
like C just to give ourselves a variable
to start thinking and talking about well
I might talk about doors as being an
array and so if I want to express the
middle door I could just in pseudo code
say doors bracket middle I'm assuming
that someone has done the math to figure
out what the middle door is but that's
easy enough to do and then doors if the
number we're looking for is less than
Doors by bracket middle then search door
zero through doors middle minus one so
again this is a more pedantic way of
taking what's a pretty intuitive idea
search the left half search the right
half but start to now describe it in
terms of
actual indices or indexes like we did
with our array notation the last
scenario of course is if the number is
greater than the doors bracket middle
then Rave would have wanted to search
the middle door plus one so one over
through doors n minus one
through n minus 1. so again just a way
of sort of describing a little more
syntactically what it is that's going on
so how might we translate this now into
Big O notation
well in the worst case
how many steps total
might raise binary search algorithm have
taken given seven doors or given more
generically n doors
how many times could she go left or go
right before finding herself with one or
no doors left
what's the way to think about that
oh yeah in the middle
log in so there's login again and even
if you're not feeling wholly comfortable
with your logarithm still pretty much in
programming and in computer science more
generally anytime we talk about some
algorithm that's dividing and conquering
in half in half in half or any other
multiple it's probably involving
logarithms in some sense and log base n
essentially refers to the number of
times you can divide n by two until you
bottom out at just a single door or
equivalently zero doors left so log in
so we might say that indeed binary
search is in Big O of login because the
door that Rave opened last this one
happened to be three doors away and
actually if you do the math here that
roughly works out to be exactly that
case if we add one it's sort of
um and if seven doors or roughly eight
we were able to search it in just three
total steps what about Omega notation
though like in the best case Rave might
have gotten lucky she opened the door
and there it is so how might we describe
a lower bound on the running time of
linear of a binary search
yeah
say again
Omega of one so here too we see that in
some cases binary search and linear
search like they're pretty equivalent
and so this is why sometimes it's
considered it's sometimes compelling to
consider both the best case and the
worst case because honestly in general
who really cares if you just get lucky
once in a while and your algorithm is
super fast what you probably care about
is what's the worst case how long are my
users how long am I going to be sitting
there watching some spinning hourglass
or a beach ball trying to give my uh
give myself an answer to a pretty big
problem well odds are you're going to
generally care about Big O notation so
indeed moving forward we'll generally
talk about the running time of
algorithms often in terms of big oh a
little less so in terms of Omega but
understanding the range can be important
depending on the nature of the data that
you're going to actually be given here
all right let me pause and see if there
is any questions
any questions here
yes thank you
[Music]
yeah that's a really good question and
if I can generalize it how do you
guarantee that you can do this at scale
which algorithm is better I've sort of
led us down this road of implying that
rave's second algorithm binary search is
better because it's so much faster it's
log of n in the worst case instead of
Big O event but Rave was given an
advantage when she came up here and that
the doors were already sorted and so
that sort of invites the question well
given a whole bunch of random data
either a small data set or heck
something Google size with millions
billions of pieces of data should you
sort it first from smallest to largest
and then search or should you just Dive
Right In and search it linearly
like how might you think about that if
you are Google for instance and you've
got millions billions of web pages
should they just go with linear search
because it's always going to work even
though it might be slow or should they
invest the time in sorting all of that
data we'll see how in a bit
and then search it more efficiently like
how do you decide between those options
[Music]
yeah if you had to sort the data first
and we don't yet formally know how to do
this but obviously as humans we could
probably figure it out you do have to
look at all of the data anyway and so
you're sort of wasting your time if
you're sorting it only then to go and
search it but maybe it depends a bit
more like that's absolutely right and if
you're just searching for one thing in
life then that's probably a waste of
time to sort it and then search it
because you're just adding to the
process but what's another scenario in
which you might not worry about that
whereby it might make sense to sort it
and then search yeah
[Music]
yeah exactly so if your problem is a
google-like problem where you have more
than just one user who's searching for
more than just one web page probably you
should incur the cost up front and sort
the whole thing because every subsequent
request thereafter is going to be faster
faster faster because it's going to be
Raves algorithm of binary search binary
search binary search that's going to add
up way to be way fewer steps than doing
linear search multiple times so again
kind of depends on the use case and kind
of depends on how important it is and
this happens even in like real world
context I think back always to graduate
school when I was writing some code to
analyze some large data set and honestly
it was actually easier at the time for
me to write pretty inefficient but
hopefully correct code because you know
what I could just go to sleep for eight
hours and let it analyze this really big
data set I didn't have to bother writing
more complex code to sort it just to run
it more efficiently why because I was
the only user and I only needed to run
these queries once and so this was kind
of a reasonable approach reasonable
until I woke up 8 hours later and my
code was incorrect and now I had to
spend another eight hours re-running it
after fixing it but even there you see
an example where what is your most
precious resource is it time to run the
code is it time to write the code is it
the amount of memory the computer is
using these are all resources we'll
start to talk about because it really
depends on what your goals are any
questions then on upper bounds lower
bounds or each of these two searches
linear or binary yeah
[Music]
when analyzing running time does the
Sorting step count if you want it to if
you actually do it at the moment it did
not apply I just gave Rave the luxury of
knowing that the data was sorted but if
I really wanted to charge her for the
amount of time it took to find that
number six I should have added the time
to sort plus the time to search and in
fact that's a road will go down why
don't we go ahead and Pace ourselves as
before let's take a 10 minute break here
and when we come back we'll write some
actual code
so we've seen a couple searches linear
search in binary search which to be fair
we saw back in week zero but let's
actually translate at least one of those
now to some code using this building
block from last week where we can
actually Define an array if we want like
an array of integers called numbers so
let me switch over to vs code here let
me go ahead and start a program called
numbers dot C and in numbers dot C let
me go ahead here and how about let's
include our familiar header files so
cs50.h I'll include standardio.h that we
can get input and print input if we want
and now I'm going to go ahead and give
myself int main void no command line
arguments today so I'll leave that as
void and I'm going to go ahead and give
myself an array of how about seven
numbers so I'll call it int number seven
and then I can fill this array with
numbers like numbers bracket zero can be
the number four and numbers bracket one
could be the number six and numbers
bracket two can be the number eight and
this is the same list that we saw when
Amina a bit ago where it was four then
six then eight but you know what there's
actually another syntax I can show you
here if you know in advance in a c
program that you want an array of
certain values and you know therefore
how many of those values you want you
can actually do this little trick using
curly braces you can say don't worry
about how big this is it's going to be
implicit by way of these curly braces
here I can do four six eight two seven
five zero close curly brace so it's a
somewhat new use of curly braces but
this has the effect of giving me an
array called numbers inside of which are
a whole bunch of integers how many the
compiler can infer it from what's ever
inside these curly braces and it seems
to be of size one two three four five
six seven and all seven elements will be
initialized with four six eight two
seven five zero respectively so just a
minor optimization code wise to tighten
up what would have otherwise been like
eight separate lines of code now let's
go ahead and Implement linear search as
we called it and you can do this in a
bunch of ways but I'm going to do it
like this for INT I gets zero I is less
than seven
I plus plus then inside of my Loop I'm
going to ask the question well if the
numbers at location I equals equals as
we ask the Domina the number zero then
I'm going to go ahead and do something
like printf found backslash n
and then I'm going to return 0 just
because of last week's discussion of
returning a value for main when all is
well I'm going to return 0 by convention
just a signal that indeed I found what
I'm looking for otherwise on what line
do I want to go and add
a printf like not found and returns
something other than zero right I don't
think I want an else here per our pseudo
code earlier so on what line would you
prefer I sort of insert a default
scenario not found and I'll return an
error
uh yeah over here
[Music]
nice so at the end of the for Loop
because you want to give the program or
volunteer earlier a chance to go through
all of the doors all of the numbers but
if you go through the whole thing
through the whole loop at the very end
you probably just want to conclude not
found backslash n and then return
something like positive one just to
signify that an error happens and again
this was a minor detail last week
anytime Maine is successful the
programming convention is to return zero
that means all is well and if something
goes wrong like you didn't find what
you're looking for you might return
something other than zero like positive
one maybe positive two or even negative
numbers if you want all right well let
me go ahead and save this let me do make
numbers hopefully no syntax errors
all good so far dot slash numbers enter
all right and it's found as I would hope
it would be and just as a little check
let's search for something that's
definitely not there like the number uh
negative one let me go ahead and
recompile the code with make numbers let
me rerun the code with DOT slash numbers
and hopefully okay not found so proof by
example seems to be working correctly
but let's make things a little more
interesting now right now I'm using just
an array of integers let me go ahead and
introduce maybe an array of strings
instead and maybe this time I'll store a
bunch of names and not just integers but
actual strings of names so how might I
do this well let me go back to my code
here I'm going to switch us over to
maybe a file called names.c and in here
I'll go ahead and include cs50.h I'll
include standard io.h and I'm going to
go ahead and for now include a new
friend from last week string.h which
gives me some string related
functionality in main void because I'm
not going to bother with any command
line Arguments for now and now if I want
an array of strings I could do something
like this string names bracket 7 and
then I could start doing like before
names bracket zero could be someone like
Bill and names bracket one could be
someone like Charlie and so forth but
there's this new uh Improvement I can
make let me just let the compiler figure
out how many names there are and using
curly braces I'll do Bill and then
Charlie and then Fred and then George
and then Ginny and then Percy and then
Ron if there's the pattern there all
right so now I have these seven names as
strings let's do something similar so
for INT
I get zero I is less than seven as
before I plus plus as before and inside
of the loop let's this time check for
the string in question and suppose we're
searching for Ron arbitrarily he is
there so we should eventually find him
let me go ahead and say if uh names
bracket I equals quote unquote Ron then
inside of my if condition I'm going to
say printf found just like before and
I'm going to return 0 just because all
is well and I'm going to take your
advice from the get-go this time and at
the end of the loop print out not found
because if I get this far I have not
printed found and I have not returned
already so I'm just going to go ahead
and return one and after printing not
found all right let me go ahead and
cross my fingers as always make names
this time
[Music]
and it doesn't seem to like my code here
this is perhaps a new error that you
might not have seen yet in names.c line
11 so that's this line here my if
condition uh result of comparison
against a string literal is unspecified
use an explicit string comparison
function instead I mean that's kind of a
mouthful and first time you see it
you're probably not going to know how to
make sense of that but it does kind of
draw our attention to something being
awry with the equality checking here
with equal equals and Ron and here's
where again we've been telling sort of a
white lie for the past couple of weeks
strings are a thing in C strings are a
thing in programming but recall from
last week I did disclaim there's no such
thing as a string data type technically
because it's not a primitive in the way
an INT and a float and a bull are that
are sort of built into the language you
can't just use equal equals to compare
two strings you actually have to use a
special function that's in this header
file we talked brief about last week in
that header file was string length or
Sterling but there's other functions
instead as well let me in fact go ahead
and open up the manual pages and if we
go to string.h let me scroll down a bit
in string.h you can perhaps infer what
function will probably take the place of
equals equals for today
what do we want to use yeah
so stir comp strcmp which apparently
Compares two strings and if I click on
that we'll see more information and
indeed if I click on stir comp we'll see
under the synopsis that okay I need to
use the cs50 library header file and
string.h as I already have here is its
prototype which is telling me that stir
comp takes two strings S1 and S2 that
are presumably going to be compared and
it returns an integer which is
interesting so let's let's read on the
description of this function is that it
Compares two strings case sensitively so
uppercase or lowercase matters just FYI
and then let's look at the return value
here the return value of this function
returns an INT less than zero if S1
comes before S2 zero if S1 is the same
as S2 or an inch greater than zero if S1
comes after S2 so the reason that this
function returns an integer and not just
a Bool true or false is that it actually
will allow us to sort these things
eventually because if you can tell me if
two strings come in this order or in
this order or they're the same you need
three possible return values and a bull
of course only gives you two but an ins
gives you like 4 billion even though we
just need the three so zero or a
positive number or a negative number is
what this function returns and the
documentation goes on to explain what we
mean by ASCII medical order recall that
capital A is 65 capital B is 66 and it's
those underlying ASCII or Unicode
numbers that a computer uses to figure
out whether something comes before it or
after it like in a dictionary but for
our purposes now we only care about
equality so I'm going to go ahead and do
this if I want to compare names bracket
I against Ron I use Stir pair more stir
comp names bracket I comma quote unquote
Ron so it's a little more involved than
actually using equals equals which does
work for integers Longs and certain
other values but for Strings it turns
out we need to use a more powerful
function why well last week recall what
a string really is it's an array of
characters and so whereas you can use
equals equals for single characters stir
comp as we'll eventually see is going to
compare multiple characters for us
there's more logic there there's a loop
needed and that's why it comes with the
string library but it doesn't just work
out of the box with equals equals alone
that would literally be comparing two
things not to arrays of things and we'll
come back to this next week as to what's
really going on under the hood so let me
go ahead and fix one bug that I just
realized I made I want to check if the
return value of stir compare is equal to
zero because per the documentation that
meant they're the same all right let me
go ahead and make names this time now it
compiles dot slash names enter
found and just as a sanity check let's
check someone outside the family
searching now for Hermione after
recompiling the code after rerunning the
code and she's not in fact found so
here's just a similar implementation of
linear search not for integers this time
but instead for Strings the subtlety
really being we need a helper function
stir compare to actually do the the leg
work for us of comparing two arrays of
characters
all right questions on either of these
implementations yeah in the middle
[Music]
good question if I had not fixed what I
claimed was a mistake earlier and I did
this and we saw an example of this last
week actually if a function returns an
integer be it negative or positive or
zero
when you get back zero the expression
the Boolean expression will be
considered false so 0 equals false
always if a function returns any
positive number or any negative number
that's going to be interpreted as true
even if it's positive or negative
whether it's 1 negative one two negative
two and so if I did this this would be
saying the opposite so if I were to say
this if stir compare of names bracket I
and Hermione that's implicitly like
saying this
does not equal zero or it means sort of
is true but you don't want to check for
true because again we're comparing
integers here so the reason I did zero
here in this case is that it explicitly
checks for the return value that means
they're the same and yeah follow up
River
yes you might not have seen this yet but
you can express the equivalent because
if you want to this if you want to check
if this is false you can actually use an
exclamation point known as a bang in
programming that inverts the meaning so
false becomes true true becomes false so
this would be another way of expressing
it this is arguably a worse design
though because the documentation
explicitly says you should be checking
for zero or a positive value or a
negative value and this little trick
well correct and I think you can make a
reasonable case for it Center of hides
that detail and I would argue instead
for the first way checking for equals
equals zero instead and if that's a
little subtle not to worry we'll come
back to sort of a little syntactic
tricks like that before long other
questions on linear search in these two
forms
is there another hand or hands two hands
no okay just holler if I missed so let's
now actually take this one step further
suppose that we want to write a program
that maybe implements something a little
more like a phone book that has both
names and numbers and not just integers
but actual phone numbers well we could
escalate things like this we could now
have two arrays one called names one
called numbers and I'm going to use
strings for the numbers now the phone
numbers because in most communities
phone numbers might have dashes pluses
parentheses so something that really
looks more like a string even though we
call it a phone number probably don't
want to use an INT lest we throw away
those kinds of details so let me switch
back to vs code here and let's do one
more program this one in a file called
phonebook.c and now let me go ahead and
do the same let me include cs50.h let me
include standard io.h and let me include
string.h I'm going to instead again do
int main void and then inside of my
program I'm going to give myself two
arrays the efficient way this time
string names will be just two of us this
time how about Carter and me and then
I'll give myself oops typo already if I
want this to be an array I don't have to
specify the number the compiler can
count for me but I do need to the square
brackets then for numbers I'm again
going to use a string uh array
specifying with the curly braces that
how about Carter can be at one six one
seven four nine five one thousand and
how about my own number here one nine
four nine four six eight oh pattern
appearing two seven five zero will be
mine why mine well I've just kind of
lined things up so Carter's number is
apparently uh first in this array and
I'm claiming that he'll be first in this
array respectively I David will be the
first the second in the names array and
second in the numbers red if you want to
have a little fun with programming feel
free to text or call me sometime at that
number so now let's actually use this
data in some way let's go ahead and
actually search for my own name and
number here so let me do for INT I get
zero there's two of us this time so I
less than two and then I plus plus as
before and now I'm going to practice
what I preached earlier and I'm going to
use Stir compare to find my name in this
case and I'm going to say if stir comp
of names bracket I
equals quote unquote David
and that equals zero meaning they're the
same then just as before I'm going to go
ahead and print something out but this
time I'm going to make the program more
useful not just say found or not found
now I'm implementing a phone book like
the contacts app on iOS or Android so
I'm going to say something like quote
unquote found percent s backslash n and
then actually plug in numbers bracket I
to correspond to the current names
bracket I and then overturn 0 as before
and then down here if we get all the way
through the loop and David's not there
for some reason I'm going to print as
before not found and then return one so
let me go ahead and compile this with
make phone book dot slash phone book and
it seems to have found the number
so this code I'm going to claim is
correct it's kind of stupid because I've
just made a phone book or a contacts app
that only supports two people they're
only going to be me and Carter this
would be like downloading the contacts
app on a phone and you can only call two
people in the world there's no ability
to add names or edit things that of
course could come later using get string
or something else but for now for the
sake of discussion I've just hard-coded
two names and two numbers but for what
it does I claim this is correct it's
going to find me and print out my number
but is it well designed let's start to
now consider if we're not just using
arrays but are we using them well we
started to use them last week but are we
using them well this weekend what might
I even mean by using an array well or
designing this program well
any critiques or concerns
with why this might not be the best road
for us to be going down when I want to
implement something like a phone book
with pieces of information it seems all
too vulnerable to just mistakes for
instance if I screw up the number the
actual number of names in the names
array such that it's now more or less
than is in the numbers array or vice
versa it feels like there's not a tight
relationship between those pieces of
data and it just sort of is trusting on
the honor System that anytime I use
names bracket I that it re that it uh
lines up with numbers bracket I and
that's fine if you're the one writing
the code you're probably not going to
really screw this up but if you start
collaborating with someone else or the
program's getting much much longer the
odds that you or your colleagues
remember that you're sort of just
trusting that names and numbers line up
like this is going to fail eventually
someone's not going to realize that and
just the code is going to break and
you're going to start outputting the
wrong numbers for names which is to say
it'd be much nicer if we could somehow
couple these two pieces of data names
and numbers a little more tightly
together so that you're not just
trusting that these two independent
variables names and numbers have this
kind of relationship with themselves so
let's consider how we might solve this a
new feature today that we'll introduce
is generally known as a data structure
in C we have the ability to invent our
own data types if you will data types
that the authors of C decades ago just
didn't Envision or just didn't think
were necessary because we can Implement
them ourselves similar to scratch just
as you could create custom puzzle pieces
or in C you can create custom functions
so in C can you create your own types of
data that go beyond the built-in ins and
floats and even strings you can make for
instance a person data type or a
candidate data type in the context of
Elections or a person data type more
generically that might have a name and a
number so how might we do this well let
me go here and propose
that if we want to define a person
wouldn't it be nice if we could have a
person data type and then we could have
an array called people and maybe that
array is our only array with two things
in it two persons in it but somehow
those data types these persons would
have both a name and a number associated
with them so we don't need two separate
arrays we need one array of persons a
brand new data type so how might we do
this well if we want every person in the
world or in this program to have a name
and a number we literally write out
first those two data types give me a
string called name give me a string
called number semicolon after each and
then we wrap that those two lines of
code with this syntax which at first
glance is a little cryptic it's a lot of
words all of a sudden but typedef is a
new keyword today that defines a new
data type this is the C keyword that
lets you create your own data type for
the very first time so struct is another
related keyword that tells the compiler
that this isn't just a simple data type
like an INT or a float renamed or
something like that it actually is a
structure it's got some Dimensions to it
like two things in it or three things in
it or even 50 things inside of it
the last word down here is the name that
you want to give your data type and it
weirdly goes after the curly braces but
this is how you invent a data type
called person and what this code is
implying is that henceforth the compiler
clang will know that a person is
composed of a name that's a string and a
number that's a string and you don't
have to worry about having multiple
arrays now you can just have an array of
people moving forward
so how can we go about using this well
let me go back to my code from before
where I was implementing a phone book
and why don't we enhance the phone book
code a little bit by borrowing some of
that new syntax let me go to the top of
my program above Main and Define a type
that's a structure or a data structure
that has a name inside of it and that
has a number inside of it and the name
of this new structure again is going to
be called person
inside of my code now let me go ahead
and delete this old stuff temporarily
let me give myself an array called
people of size 2 and I'm going to use
the non-ters way to do this I'm not
going to use the curly braces I'm going
to more pedantically spell out what I
want in this array of size 2. at
location zero which is the first person
in an array because you always start
counting at zero I'm going to give that
person a name of quote unquote Carter
and the dot is admittedly one new piece
of syntax today too the dot means go
inside of that structure and access the
variable called name and give it this
value Carter similarly if I want to give
Carter a number I can go into people
bracket zero DOT number and give that
the same thing as before plus one six
one seven four nine five one thousand
and then I can do the same for myself
here people bracket where should I go
okay one because again two elements but
we started counting at zero bracket name
equals quote unquote David and then
lastly people bracket one dot number
equals quote unquote plus one uh nine
four nine two uh four six eight two
seven five zero so now if I scroll down
here to my logic I don't think this part
needs to change too much I'm still for
the sake of discussion gonna iterate two
times from I is zero on up two but not
through two but I think this line of
code needs to change
how should I now refer to the ith
person's name as I iterate
[Music]
what should I compare quote unquote
David to this time let me see on the end
here
yeah people bracket i.name why because
people is the name of the array bracket
I is the ith person that we're iterating
over in the current Loop for zero then
one maybe higher if it had more people
then dot is our new syntax for going
inside of a data structure and accessing
a variable therein which in this case is
name and so I can compare David just as
before so it's a little more verbose but
now arguably this is a better program
because now these people
our full-fledged data types unto
themselves there's no more honor System
inside of my Loop that this is going to
line up because in just a moment I'm
going to fix this one Last Remnant of
the previous version and if I can call
back on you again what should I change
numbers bracket I to this time
[Music]
DOT number exactly So Gone is the honor
System that just assumes that bracket I
in this array lines up with bracket I in
this other array now why there's only
one array it's an array called people
the things that stores are persons a
person has a name and a number and so
even though it's kind of marginal
admittedly given that this is a short
program and given that this kind of made
things look more complicated at first
glance we're now laying the foundation
for just a better design because you
really can't screw up now the
association of names with numbers
because every person's name and number
is so to speak encapsulated inside of
the same data type and that's a term of
Art in CS encapsulation means to
encapsulate that is contained related
pieces of information and thus we have a
person that encapsulates two other data
types name and number and this just sets
the foundation for all of the cool stuff
we've talked about and you use every day
how what is an image well recall that an
image is a bunch of pixels or dots on
the screen every one of those dots has
RGB values associated with it red green
and blue you could imagine now creating
a structure in C probably where maybe
you have three values three variables
one called red one called green one
called blue and then you could name the
thing not person but pixel and now you
could store in c three different colors
some amount of red some green some blue
and collectively treat it as the color
of a pixel and you can imagine doing
something similar perhaps for video or
music music you might have three
variables one for the musical note the
duration the loudness of it and you can
imagine coming up with your own data
type for music as well so this is a
little low level we're just using like a
familiar contacts application but we now
have the away in code to express most
any type of data that we might want to
implement or discuss ultimately so any
questions now on struct or defining our
own types the purposes for which are to
use arrays but use them more responsibly
now in a better design but also to lay
the foundation for implementing cooler
and cooler stuff
per our week zero discussion yeah
what's the difference between this and
an object in an object-oriented language
so a slight side note C is not object
oriented languages like Java and C plus
plus and others which you might have
heard of programmed yourself had friends
program in or object oriented languages
in those languages they have things
called classes or objects which are
interrelated and objects can store not
just data like variables objects can
also store functions and you can kinda
sort of do this in C but it's not sort
of conventional in C you have data
structures that store data in languages
like Java and C plus you have objects
that store data and functions together
python is an object-oriented language as
well so we'll see this issue in a few
weeks but let me wave my hands at it for
now yeah
yes could you use this struck to
redefine how an INT is defined short
answer yes we talked a couple of times
now about integer overflow and most
recently you might have seen me mention
um the bug in iOS and Mac OS that was
literally related to an INT overflow
that's probably that's the result of ins
only storing four bytes or 32 bits or
even a long is 64 bits or eight bytes
but it's finite but if you want to
implement some Financial software or
some scientific or mathematical software
that allows you to count way bigger than
a typical int or a long you could
imagine coming up with your own
structure and in fact in some languages
there is a structure called Big int
which allows you to express even bigger
numbers how well maybe you store inside
of a big int an array of values and you
somehow allow yourself to store more and
more bits based on how high you want to
be able to count so in short yes we now
have the ability now to do most anything
we want in the language even if it's not
built in for us
other questions
[Music]
could you define a name and a number in
the same line uh sort of it starts to
get syntactically a little messy so I
did it a little more pedantically line
by line
good question oh we're here
[Music]
prototypes you have to do in C you have
to Define anything you're going to use
or declare anything you're going to use
before you actually use it so it is
deliberate that I put it in the top of
my code in this file otherwise the
compiler would not know what I mean by
person when I first use it here on
what's line 14. so it has to come first
or it has to be put into something like
a header file so that you know so you'll
include it at the very top of your code
other questions over here uh yeah
[Music]
yeah good question we'll come back to
this later in the term when we talk
about SQL a database language and
storing things in actual databases
generally speaking even though we humans
call things uh phone numbers or in the
US we have social security numbers those
types of numbers often have other
punctuation in it like dashes
parentheses uh pluses and so forth you
could not store any of that syntax or
that punctuation inside of an INT You
Could Only store numbers so one
motivation for using a string is just I
can store whatever the human wanted me
to store including parentheses and so
forth another reason for storing things
as strings even if they look like
numbers is in the context of like ZIP
codes in the United States again we'll
come back to this but long story short
years ago actually I was using Microsoft
Outlook for my email client and
eventually I switched to Gmail and this
is like 10 plus years ago now and
Outlook at the time lets you export all
of your contacts as a CSV file comma
separated values more on that in the
weeks to come too and that just means I
could download a text file with all of
my friends and family and their numbers
inside of it unfortunately I opened that
same CSV file with Excel I think at the
time just to kind of spot check it and
see if what's in there was what it was
expected and I must have instinctively
hit like command or control s to save it
and Excel at least has this habit of
sort of reformatting your data things
look like numbers it treats them as
numbers and Apple Numbers does the two
Google spreadsheets does this too
nowadays but long story short I then
imported imported my mildly saved CSV
file into Gmail and now 10 plus years
later I'm still occasionally finding
friends and family members whose zip
codes are in Cambridge Massachusetts
2138 which is missing the zero because
we here in Cambridge are 02138 and
that's because I treated or I let Excel
treat what looks like a number as an
actual number or int and now leading
zeros become a problem because
mathematically they mean nothing but in
the mail system they do
sending envelopes and such all right
other final questions here
yeah so could I have created used a 2d
or two-dimensional array to solve the
problem earlier of having just one array
yes but uh one I'd argue it's less
readable especially as I get lots of
names and numbers and two that too is
also kind of relying on the honor System
it would be all too easy to Omit some of
the square brackets in the
two-dimensional array so I would argue
it too is not is not as good as
introducing a struct more on that down
the road two-dimensional arrays just
means arrays of arrays as you might
infer
all right so now that we have this
ability to store different types of data
like contacts in a phone book having
names and addresses let's actually take
a step back and consider how we might
now solve one of the original problems
uh by actually sorting the information
we're given in advance and considering
per our discussion earlier just how
costly how time consuming is that
because that might tip the scales in
favor of sorting sorting then searching
or maybe just not sorting and only
searching it'll give us a sense of just
how expensive so to speak uh sorting
something actually is what's the
formulation of this problem it's the
same thing as week zero we've got input
to sort we want it to up be outputted as
sorted so for instance if we're taking
unsorted input as input we want the
sorted output as the result more
concretely if we've got numbers like
these six three eight five two seven
four one which are just randomly
arranged numbers we want to get back out
one two three four five six seven eight
so we just want those things to be so
supported so again inside of the black
box here is going to be SWA one or more
algorithms that actually gets this job
done so how might we go about doing this
well just to vary things a bit more I
think we have some a chance here for a
bit more audience participation uh but
this time we need eight people if we may
all you have to be comfortable appearing
on the internet okay so this is actually
quite convenient that you're all quite
close I've got one two three four five
six seven
oh okay and someone volunteering their
friend number eight
come on down come on down or and if you
could I'm going to set things up if you
all could join Valerie my colleague over
there to give you a prop to use here
we'll go ahead in just a moment
and try to find some numbers at hand
[Music]
in just a moment each of our volunteers
is going to be representing an integer
and that integer is ultimately is
initially going to be in unsorted order
and I claim that using an algorithm
step-by-step instructions we can
probably sort these folks in at least a
couple of different ways so they're in
wardrobe right now uh just getting their
very own Harbor T-shirt with a jersey
number on it which will then represent
an element of our array
give us just a moment to finish
getting the attire ready they're being
handed a shirt and a number
and let me ask the audience for just a
moment as we have these numbers up here
on the screen these numbers too are
unsorted they're just in random order
and let me ask the audience how would
you go about sorting these eight numbers
on the screen
how would you go about sorting these
yeah what are your thoughts
[Music]
remember
okay
[Music]
so just to just to recap you would start
with one of the numbers on the end you
would look to the number to the right or
to the left of it depending on which end
you start at and if it's out of order
you would just start to swap things and
that seems reasonable there's a whole
bunch of mistakes to fix here because
things are pretty out of order but
probably if you start to solve small
problems at a time you can achieve the
end result of getting the whole thing
sorted other instincts if you were just
handed these numbers how you might go
about sorting them
how might you get in the back
okay
I like that so to recap there find the
smallest one first and and put it at the
beginning if I heard you correctly and
then presumably you could do that again
and again and again and that would seem
to give you a couple of different
algorithms and if you all are tired here
do you want to come on up if you're
ready
we had some felt volunteers too come on
over
so if you all would like to line
yourselves up facing the audience in
exactly this order so whoever is number
zero should be way over here and whoever
is number five should be way over there
feel free to distance as much as you'd
like and Screech a little this way if
you could
okay
all right and make a little more room so
seven let's see five two seven four
hopefully one uh and yeah keep them to
the side okay one uh six
and there we go three come on over three
he's looking for you all right so here
we have an array of eight numbers eight
integers if you will and you wanna each
say a quick hello to the group
hello I'm Quinn go Canada Day
hi everyone I'm agird
hey I'm Mitchell
hi I'm Brett and also go Canada
I'm Hannah go Appley
hi I'm Matthew goholbert
hi I'm Miriam gowenthrop
hi I'm Celeste they go Strauss wonderful
but welcome all to the stage and let's
just visualize perhaps organically how
you ate would solve this problem so we
currently have the number zero through
seven quite out of order could you go
ahead and just sort yourselves
from zero through seven
okay so what did they just do well okay
yes first of all yes very well done
how would you describe what they just
did
well let's do this could you go back
into that order on the screen five two
seven four one six three oh
and could you do exactly what you just
did again sort yourselves
all right put it okay I guess well done
again
all right so admittedly there's kind of
a lot going on because each of you
except number four are doing something
in parallel all at the same time and
that's not really how A computer
typically works just like a computer can
only look at one memory location at one
Locker at a time so can a computer only
move one number at a time sort of
opening a locker checking what's there
moving it as needed so let's try this
more methodically based on the two
audience suggestions if you all could
randomize yourself again to five two
seven four one six three zero let's take
the second of those approaches first I'm
gonna look at these numbers and even
though I as the human can obviously see
all the numbers and I just kind of have
the intuition for how to fix this we've
got to be more methodical because
eventually we got to translate this to
pseudo code and then code so let me see
I'm going to search for as you propose
the smallest number and I'm going to
start from left to right I could do it
right to left but left to right this
tends to be convention all right five at
this moment is the smallest number I've
seen so I'm going to sort of remember
that in a variable if you will now I'm
going to take one more step two okay two
I'm going to compare to the variable
people in mind obviously smaller I'm
going to forget about five and only now
remember two as the now smallest element
seven nope I'm going to ignore that
because it's not smaller than the two I
have in mind four one okay I'm going to
update the variable in mind because
that's indeed smaller now obviously we
the humans know that's getting pretty
small maybe it's the end I have to check
all values to see if there's something
even smaller because 6 is not 3 is not
but zero is and what's your name again
Celeste where should Celeste or number
zero go according to this proposed
algorithm
all right all I'm seeing a lot of this
so at the beginning of the array so
before doing this for real let's have
you pop out in front and could you all
shift and make room for Celeste
is this a good idea to have all of them
move or equivalently move everything in
the array to make room for Celeste and
number zero over there
no probably not that felt like a lot of
work and even though it happened pretty
quickly that's like seven steps to
happen just to move her in place so what
would be marginally smarter perhaps a
little more efficient perhaps what's
that swapping what do you mean by swap
okay replace two values so if you want
to go back to where you were one step
over number five he's not in the right
place he's got to move eventually so you
know what if that's where Celeste
belongs why don't we just swap five and
zero so if you want to go ahead and
exchange places with each other notice
what's just happened the problem trying
to solve I'm trying to solve has gotten
smaller instead of being size eight now
it's size seven now granted I moved five
to another wrong location but if these
numbers started off randomly it doesn't
really matter where five goes until we
get him into the right place so I think
we've improved and now if I go back my
Loop is sort of coming back around I can
ignore Celeste and make this a seven
step problem and not eight because I
know she's in the right place two seems
to be the smallest I'll remember that
not seven not four one seems to be the
smallest now I know as a human this
should be my next smallest but why
intuitively should I keep going do you
think
I can't sort of optimize as a human and
just say number one let's let's get you
into the right place I still want to
check the whole array why yeah
maybe there's another one and that could
be another problem altogether other
thoughts yeah
there could be another zero indeed but I
I did go through the list once right and
I I kind of know there isn't your
thoughts
[Music]
yeah I don't necessarily know what is
there and honestly I only stipulated
earlier that I'm using one variable in
my mind I could use two and remember
this two smallest elements I've seen I
could use three variables four but then
I'm going to start to use a lot of space
in addition to time so if I've
stipulated that I only have one variable
to solve this problem I don't know
anything more about these elements
because the only thing I'm remembering
at this moment is number one is the
smallest element I've seen so I'm going
to keep going six nope three nope five
nope okay I know that number one and
your name was Hannah is the next
smallest element I could have everyone
move over to make room but nope two you
know even though you're so close to
where I want you I'm just going to keep
it simple and swap you two so granted
I've made the problem a little worse but
on average I could get lucky too and
just pop number two into the right place
now let me just accelerate this I can
now ignore Hannah and Celeste making the
problem size six instead of eight so
it's getting smaller seven is the
smallest nope now fours two is the
smallest still two still two still two
so let's go ahead and swap two and seven
and now I'll just kind of orchestrate it
verbally for you're about to have to do
something so we now have four seven six
three five okay three could you swap
with four
all right now we have seven six four
five okay four could you swap with seven
now we have six seven five uh five could
you swap with six
and now we have seven six six would you
swap at seven and now perhaps a round of
applause they've sorted themselves okay
hang on there one minute
so we'll do this one other approach and
my God that felt so much slower than the
first approach but that's one because I
was kind of providing a long voice over
but two we were doing one thing at a
time whereas the first time you guys had
the luxury of moving like eight
different CPUs brains if you will we're
all operating at the same time and
computers like that exist if you have a
computer with multiple cores so to speak
that's like having a computer that
technically can do multiple things at
once but software typically at least as
we've written it thus far can only do
one thing at a time so in a bit we'll
add up all of these steps but for now
let's take one other approach if you all
could reorder yourselves like that five
two seven four one six three zero let's
take the other approach that was
recommended by just fixing small
problems and see where this gets us so
we're back in the original order five
and two are clearly out of order so you
know what let's just bite this problem
off now it's five and two could you swap
now let me take a next step five and
seven I think you're okay there's a gap
yes but that might not be a big deal
seven and four problem let's have you
swap
okay seven and one let's have you swap
seven and six let's have you swap seven
and three you swap seven and zero you
swap now let me pause for just a moment
still not sorted so I'm clearly not done
but have I improved the problem
right I I can't cheat like before or I
can't optimize like before because zero
is obviously not here so let's stay
still way back there so it's not like
I've gone from eight steps to seven to
six just yet but have I made any
improvements
yes in what sense is this improved
what's a concrete thing you could point
to is better
[Music]
yeah
sort of the highest number which is
indeed seven and conversely if you
prefer Celeste is one step closer to the
beginning now worst case Celeste is
going to have to move one step on each
iteration so I might need to do this
thing like n total times to move her all
the way over but that might work out
okay let me see uh two and five you're
good five and four swap you five and one
let's swap you five and six you're good
six and three let's swap you
six and zero let's swap you six and
seven you're good and I think now notice
that the high values as you noted are
sort of bubbling up if you will to the
end of the list to enforce you're good
four in one let's swap four and five
good five and three swap five and zero
swap
five six seven of course are good so now
you can sort of see the problem
resolving itself and let's just do this
part now faster two and one
two and four okay four and three
four and zero
all right now one and two two and three
three and zero
and good so we do have some optimization
there we don't need to keep going
because those all are sorted one and two
you're good two and zero
all right done one and zero and big
round of applause in closing okay
thank you all
um we need the puppets back but you can
keep the shirts thank you for
volunteering here uh feel free to make
your way exits left or right and let's
see if thanks to our volunteers here we
can't now
formalize a little bit what we did on
both passes here
um I claim that the first algorithm our
volunteers kindly acted out is what's
called selection sort and as the name
implied we selected the smallest
elements again and again and again
working our way from left to right
putting Celeste into the Celestia into
the right place and then continuing with
everyone else so selection sort as it's
formally called can be described for
instance with this pseudo code here 4i
from 0 to n minus one and again why this
this is just how we think about talk
about arrays the Left End is zero the
right end is n minus one where in this
case n happen to be eight people so
that's zero through seven so for I from
zero to n minus one what did I do I
found the smallest number between
numbers bracket I and numbers bracket n
minus one
so a little cryptic at first glance but
this is just a very pseudocode-like way
of saying find the smallest element
among all eight volunteers because if z
i starts at zero
and N minus 1 never changes because
there's always eight and uh eight people
so eight minus one is seven this first
says find the smallest number between
numbers bracket zero and numbers bracket
seven if you will then what do I do swap
the smallest number with numbers bracket
I so that's how we got Celeste from over
here all the way over there we just
swapped those two values what then
happens next in the pseudo code I of
course goes from zero to one and that's
the technical way of saying now find the
smallest element among the seven
remaining volunteers ignoring Celeste
this time because she was already in the
correct location so the problem went
from size 8 to size seven and if we
repeat size six five four three two one
until boom it's all done at the very end
so this is just one way of expressing in
pseudo code what we did a little more
organically in a formalization of what
we've all uh what someone volunteered
out in the audience
so if we consider then the efficiency of
this algorithm maybe abstracting in a
way now is a bunch of doors where the
leftmost again is always zero the
rightmost is always n minus one or
equivalently the second to last is n
minus two the third to last is n minus
three where n might be eight or anything
else
how do we think about or quantify the
running time of selection sort Big O of
what
I mean that was a lot of steps to be
adding up it's probably more than n
right because I went through the list
again and again it was like n plus n
minus 1 plus n minus two any instincts
here
we got like the whole team in the
orchestra now
let me let me propose we think about it
this way with with just a bit of
first time I had a
different volunteers and was eight in
this case but in generically I looked at
all eight numbers in order to decide who
was the smallest and sure enough Celeste
was at the very end she happened to be
all the way to the right but I only knew
that once I looked at all eight or all n
volunteers so that took me n steps first
but once Celeste was swapped into the
right place then my problem with size n
minus one and I had n minus one other
people to look through so that's n minus
one steps then after that it's n minus
two plus n minus 3 plus n minus four
plus dot dot dot until I had one final
step and it's obvious that I only have
one human left to consider so we might
wave our hands at this with a little
Ellipsis and just say dot dot dot plus
one for the final step now what does
this actually equal well this is where
you might think back on like your high
school math or physics textbook that has
a little cheat sheet at the end that
shows these kinds of recurrences that
happens to work out mathematically to be
n times n plus one all divided by two
that's just what that recurrence that
series actually adds up to so if you
take on faith that that math is correct
let's just now multiply this out math
work mathematically that's N squared
plus n divided by 2 or N squared divided
by 2 plus n over 2 and here's where
we're starting to get annoyingly into
the weeds like honestly as n gets really
large like a million doors or integers
or a billion web pages in Google search
engine honestly which of these terms is
going to matter the most mathematically
if N is a really big number is N squared
divided by 2 the dominant factor or is n
divided by 2 the dominant Factor
yeah N squared I mean no matter what n
is and the bigger it is the bigger uh
raising it to the power 2 is going to be
so you know what let's just wave our
hands at this because at the end of the
day as n gets really large the dominant
factor is indeed that first one and you
know what even the divided two as I
claimed earlier with our two phone book
examples were the two straight lines if
you keep zooming out essentially looked
the same when n is large enough let's
just call this on the order of N squared
so that is to say a computer scientist
would describe bubble sort as taking on
the order of N squared steps that's an
oversimplification if we really added it
up it's actually this many steps N
squared divided by 2 plus n over two but
again if we want to just be able to
generally compare two algorithms
performance I think it's going to
suffice if we look at that highest order
term to get a sense of what the graph
what the algorithm feels like if you
will or what it even looks like
graphically all right so with that said
we might describe bubble sort as being
in Big O sorry selection sort as being
in Big O of N squared but what if we
consider now the best case scenario an
opportunity to talk about a lower bound
in the best case
how many steps does selection sort take
well here we need some context like what
does it mean to be the best case or the
worst case when it comes to sorting
like what could you imagine meaning the
best possible scenario when you're
trying to sort a bunch of numbers
uh okay the whole crew here again yeah
all right they're already sorted right I
can't really imagine a better scenario
than I have to sort some numbers but
they're already sorted for me but does
this algorithm leverage that fact in
practice even if all of our humans had
lined up from zero to seven I'm pretty
sure I would have pretty naively started
here and yes Celeste happens to be here
but I only know she needs to be here
once I've looked at all eight people and
then I would have realized well that was
a waste of time I can leave Celeste B
but then what would I what would I have
done I would have ignored her position
because we're solved one problem I would
have done the same thing now for seven
people then six people so every time I
walk through I'm not doing much useful
work but I am doing those comparisons
because I don't know until I do the work
that the people were in the right order
so this would seem to imply that the
Omega notation the best case scenario
even a lower bound on the running time
would be what then
a little louder
it's still going to be N squared in fact
because the code I'm giving myself
doesn't leverage or benefit from any of
that scenario because it just mindlessly
continues to do this again and again so
in this case yes I would have claim that
the Omega notation for selection source
is also Big O of N squared so those are
the kinds of numbers to beat it seems
like the upper bound and lower bound of
selection sort are indeed N squared and
so we can also describe selection sort
therefore as being in Theta of N squared
that's the first algorithm we've had the
chance to describe that in which is to
say that it's kind of slow I mean maybe
other algorithms are slower but this
isn't the best starting point can we do
better well there's a reason that I
guided us to doing the second algorithm
second even though you verbally proposed
them in a different order this second
algorithm we did is generally known as
bubble sort and I deliberately use that
word a minute a bit ago saying the big
values are bubbling their way up to the
right to kind of capture the fact that
indeed this algorithm Works different at
least but let's consider if it's better
or worse so here we have pseudo code for
bubble sort you could write this two in
different ways but let's consider what
we did on the stage we repeated the
following n minus 1 times
we initialized at least even though I
didn't verbalize it this way a variable
like I from 0 to n minus two
n minus 2 and then I asked this question
if numbers bracket I and numbers bracket
I plus 1 are out of order
then swap them so again I just did it
more intuitively by pointing but this
would be a way with a bit of pseudo code
to describe what's going on but notice
that I'm doing something a little
differently here I'm iterating from I if
equals 0 to n minus 2. why well if I'm
comparing two things left hand and right
hand I'd still want to start at zero but
I don't want to go all the way to n
minus 1 because then I'd be going past
the boundary of my array which would be
bad I want to make sure that my left
hand I if you will stops at n minus 2 so
that when I plus 1 in my pseudo code I'm
looking at the last two elements not the
last elements and then past the boundary
that's actually a common programming
mistake that will undoubtedly soon make
but going beyond the boundaries of your
array so this pseudo code then allows me
to say
compare everyone again and again
and swap them if they're out of order
why do I repeat the whole thing n minus
1 times
like why it does it not suffice just to
do this Loop
here
think what happened with Celeste
why do I repeat this whole thing n minus
1 times
yeah and back
[Music]
indeed and I think if I can recap
accurately think back to Celeste again
and I'm sorry to keep calling on you as
our number zero each time through bubble
sort she only moved one step and so in
total if there's n locations at the end
of the day she needs to move n minus one
steps to get 0 all the way to where it
needs to be and so this inner loop if
you will where we're iterating using I
that just fixes some of the problems but
it doesn't fix all of the problems until
we do that same logic again and again
and again and so how might we quantify
the running time of this algorithm well
one way to see it is to just literally
look at the pseudo code the outer loop
repeats n minus one times by definition
it literally says that the inner loop
the for Loop also iterates n minus one
times why because it's going from zero
to n minus two and if that's hard to
think about that's the same thing as 1
to n minus one if you just add one to
both ends of the formula so that that
means you're doing n minus 1 Things N
minus 1 times so I literally multiply
how many times the outer loop is running
by the how many times the inner loop is
running which gives me sort of foil
method n minus 1 squared and I could
multiply that whole thing out well let's
consider this just a little more
methodically here if I have n minus 1 on
the outer n minus 1 on the inner let's
go ahead and foil this so N squared
minus n minus n plus 1 combine like
terms N squared minus 2N plus one and
now which of these terms is clearly
going to be dominant so to speak
the
the N squared so yes even though minus
2N is a good thing because it's
subtracting off some of the time
required plus one is not that big a
thing there's such drops in the bucket
when n gets really large like in the
millions or billions certainly that
bubble sort 2 is on the order of N
squared it's not the same exactly as
selection sore but as n gets big
honestly we're barely going to be able
to notice the difference most likely and
so it too might be said to be on the
order of N squared and if we consider
now the lower bound on Bubble shorts
running time here's where things get
potentially interesting
um what might you claim is the running
time
of bubble sort in the best case and the
best case I claim is when the numbers
are already sorted
is our pseudo code going to take that
into account
okay n why do you propose n
[Music]
yes and that's the key word to summarize
in bubble sort I do have to minimally
make one pass because if I don't look at
all n elements that I'm theoretically
just guessing if it's sorted or not like
I obviously intuitively have to look at
every element to decide yay or nay it's
in the right order and my original
pseudo code though is pretty naive it's
just going to blindly go back and forth
n times n minus 1 times again and again
and that's going to add up but what if I
add a bit of an optimization that you
might have glimpsed on the slide a
moment ago where if I compare two people
and I don't swap them compare two people
don't swap them and I go all the way
through the list comparing every pair of
adjacent people and I make no swaps it
would be kind of not just naive but
stupid to do that same process again
because if the humans have not moved I'm
not going to make any different
decisions I'm going to do nothing again
nothing again so at that point it would
be stupid very inefficient to go back
and forth and back and forth so if I
modify our pseudo code with just an
additional if condition I bet we can
speed this up inside of that same pseudo
code what if I say hey if no swaps quit
like quit prematurely before the loops
are finished running one of the loops
has gone through per the indentation
here but if I do a loop from left to
right and I have made no swaps which you
can think of as just being one other
variable that's plus plusing as I go
keeping track of how many swaps if I've
made no swaps from left to right I'm not
going to make any swaps the next time
around either so let's just quit at that
point
and that is to say in the best case if
you will when the list is already sorted
the Omega notation for bubble sort might
indeed be Omega of n if you add that
optimization so as to Short Circuit all
of that inefficient looping to do it
only as many times
as is necessary
all right let me pause to see if there's
any questions here yeah
[Music]
good question if the uh running time of
selection sort and bubble sort are both
in Big O of N squared but they are in
but selection sorts in Omega of N
squared while bubble sorts in Omega of n
which sounds better I think if I may uh
should we just always use bubble sort
yes if we think that we might benefit
over time from a lot of good case
scenarios or best case scenarios
however the goal at hand in just a bit
is going to be to do even better than
both of these so hold that question
further for a moment yeah
[Music]
oh my uh no so oh yes good question so I
say Omega then but it's a technically
Omega of n minus one maybe but again
we're throwing away low or lower order
terms and that's an advantage because
we're not comparing things ever so
precisely just like I plotted with the
or green and yellow and red chart I just
want to get a sense of the shape of
these algorithms so that when n gets
really large which of these choices is
going to matter the most at the end of
the day it's actually perfectly
reasonable to use selection sort or
bubble sort if you don't have that much
data because they're going to be pretty
fast my God our computers nowadays are
one gigahertz two gigahertz one billion
things per second one two billion things
per second but if we have large data
sets as we will later in the term and as
you might in the real world at the
Googles of the world then you're going
to be one you're going to want to be
more thoughtful and that's where we're
going today all right so let's actually
see this visualized a little bit in a
moment I'm going to change screens here
to open up what is a little
visualization tool that will give us a
sense of how these things actually work
and look at a faster rate than our
humans were able to do here on stage so
here is another visualization of a bunch
of numbers an array of numbers short
bars means small numbers tall bars mean
big numbers so instead of having the
numbers on their torsos here we just
have bars that are small or tall based
on the magnitude of the number let me go
ahead and I've pre-configured this in
advance to operate somewhat quickly
let's go ahead and do selection sort by
clicking this button and you'll see some
pink bars flying by and that's like me
walking left and right left and right to
select the next smallest number and so
what you'll see happening on the left of
this array of numbers is Celeste day if
you will and all of the other smaller
numbers are appearing on the left while
we continue to solve the remaining
problems to the right
so again we no longer have to touch the
smaller numbers here so that's why the
problem is getting smaller and smaller
and smaller over time but you can notice
now visually look at how many times
we're retracing our steps this is why
things that are N squared tend to be
frowned upon if avoidable because I'm
touching the same elements again and
again when I was walking through I kept
pointing at the same humans again and
again and that adds up so let's see if
bubble sort looks or feels a little
different let me re-randomize the thing
and let me now click bubble sort at the
top and as you might infer there's other
sorting algorithms out there not all of
which we'll look at but here's bubble
sort
same pink coloration but it's doing
something different it's two pink bars
going through again and again comparing
the adjacent numbers and you'll see that
the largest numbers are indeed bubbling
their way up to the right
but the smaller numbers like our number
zero was is only slowly making its way
over here's a comparable here's the
number one and it's going to take a
while to get all the way to the left and
here too notice how many times the same
bars are becoming pink how many times
the algorithm is retracing and retracing
its steps why because it's only solving
one problem at a time on each pass and
each time we do that we're stepping
through practically the whole array now
granted I could speed this up even
further if I really wanted to but my God
this is only what like 50 or 60 elements
something like that this is slow like
this is what N squared looks like and
feels like and now I'm just trying to
come up with words to say until we get
to the finish line here like this would
be annoying if this is the speed of
sorting and this is why I sort of
secretly sorted the numbers for Rave in
advance because it would have taken us
an annoying number of steps to get that
in place for her so those two algorithms
are N squared can we do in fact better
well to save the best algorithm for Less
let's a shorter five minute break here
and when we come back we'll do even
better than N squared
all right
so the challenge at hand is to do better
than selection sort and better than
bubble sort and ideally not just
marginally better but fundamentally
better just like in week zero that third
and final divide and conquer algorithm
was sort of fundamentally faster than
the other two so can we do better than
something on the order of N squared well
I bet we can if we start to approach the
problem a little differently the sorts
we've done thus far generally known as
comparison sorts and that kind of
captures the reality that we were doing
a huge number of comparisons again and
again and you kind of saw that in the
vertical bars that were going Pink as
everything was being compared again and
again but there's this programming
technique and it's actually a
mathematical technique known as
recursion that we've actually seen
before and this is a a building block or
a mental model we can bring to bear in
the problem to solve the Sorting problem
sort of fundamentally differently but
first let's look at it in a more
familiar context a little bit ago I
proposed this pseudo code for the binary
search algorithm and notice that what
was interesting about this code even
though I didn't call it out at the time
it's kind of cyclically defined like I
claim this is an algorithm for search
and yet it seems a little unfair that
I'm using the verb search inside of the
algorithm for search it's like an
English sort of defining a word by using
the word normally you shouldn't really
get away with that but there's something
interesting about this technique here
because even though this whole thing is
a search algorithm and I'm using my own
algorithm to search the left half or the
right half the key feature here that
doesn't normally happen in English when
you define a word in terms of a word is
that when I search the left half or
search the right half yes I'm doing the
same thing I'm using the same algorithm
but the problem is by definition half as
large so this isn't going to be a
cyclical argument in the same way this
approach by using search within search
is going to whittle the problem down and
down and down until hopefully one door
or no doors remains and so recursion is
a programming technique whereby a
function calls itself and we haven't
seen this yet in C and we haven't seen
this really in scratch but in C you can
have a function call itself and the form
that takes is like literally using the
function's name inside of the function's
implementation itself we've actually
seen this an opportunity for this once
before too think back to week zero
here's that same pseudocode for
searching for someone in an actual
physical phone book and notice these
yellow lines here we described those in
week zero as inducing a loop a cycle and
this is a very procedural approach if
you will because lines 8 and 11 are very
mechanically if you will telling me to
go back to line three to do this kind of
looping thing
but really what that's doing in the
binary search algorithm for the phone
book is it's just telling me to search
the left half or search the right half
I'm doing it more mechanically Again by
sort of telling myself what line number
to go back to but that's equivalent to
just telling myself go search the left
half search the right half the key thing
being the left half and the right half
are smaller than the original problem it
would be a bug if I just said search the
phone book search the phone book search
because obviously you never get anywhere
but if you search the half the half the
half problem gets smaller and smaller so
let's reformulate week zeros phone book
code to be not procedural as here but
recursive whereby in this search
algorithm AKA binary search formerly
called divide and conquer I'm going to
literally use also the keyword search
here notice among the benefits of doing
this is it kind of tightens the code up
makes it a little more succinct even
though that's kind of a fringe benefit
here but it's an elegant way A2 of
describing a problem by just using
having a function use itself to solve a
smaller puzzle at hand so let's now
consider a familiar problem a smaller
version the one you've dabbled with this
sort of pyramid this half pyramid from
Mario and let's throw away the the parts
that aren't that interesting and just
consider how we might up until now
implement this in C code this
left-the-line pyramid if you will let me
go over here and let me create a file
called how about
um
iteration dot C and in this file I'm
going to go ahead and include cs50.h and
I'm going to include standard in
standardio.h and the goal at hand is to
implement in C A little program that
just prints out this and exactly this
pyramid so no get string or any of that
we're just going to keep it simple and
print exactly this pyramid of height 4
here so how might I do this well let me
go ahead and in main let me first ask
the user for
um well we'll go ahead and generalize it
let's go ahead and ask the user for
Heights we're using get int as before
and I'll store that in a variable called
height and then let me go ahead and
simply call a function draw passing in
that height so for the moment let me
assume that someone somewhere has
implemented a draw function and this
then is the entirety of my program all
right unfortunately C does not come with
a draw function so let me go ahead and
invent one it doesn't need to return a
value it just needs to print something
so-called side effect so I'm going to
define a function called Draw that takes
as input and int I'll call it n for
number but I could call it anything I
want and inside of this I'm going to go
ahead and print out a left aligned
pyramid like this from top to bottom the
Salient features here are that this is a
pyramid at least in this example of
height four and on height four the first
row has one brick the second row has two
the third has three the fourth has four
that's a nice pattern that I can
probably represent in code so how might
I do this well how about for INT I gets
let me do it the old school way one and
then I is less than uh or equal to n and
then I plus plus so I'm going from one
to four just to keep myself saying here
and then inside of this Loop what do I
want to do well let me let me keep it
conventional in fact let me just change
this to be the more conventional 0 to n
even though it might not be as intuitive
because now on row 0 I want one brick on
Row one I want two bricks dot dot dot on
Row three I want four so it's kind of
offset now but I'm being more
conventional so on each row how many
bricks do I want to print well I think I
want to do this for INT J for instance
commonly common to use J after I if you
have a nested Loop let's start J at zero
and do this so long as J is less than
I Plus 1. and then do J plus plus so y i
plus one well again when I equals zero
that's the first row and I want one
brick when I equals one that's the
second row I want two bricks and dot dot
when I is 3 I want four bricks so again
I have to add one to I to get the total
number of bricks that I want to print on
the screen so inside of this nested for
Loop I'm going to do printf of a hash
with no line line new line I'm going to
save the new line for about here instead
all right the last thing I'm going to do
is copy and paste the Prototype at the
top of the file so that I can call this
and again this is sort of now week one
week two wouldn't necessarily come to
your mind as quickly as it might to mine
after all this practice but this is
something reminiscent of what you
yourselves did already for Mario
printing out a pyramid that hopefully in
a moment is going to look like this so
let me go back to my code let me run
make iteration
and let me dot slash iteration I'll type
in four and voila seems to be correct
and let's assume it's going to work for
other inputs as well oh thank you this
is
so this is indeed an example of
iteration doing something again and
again and it's very procedural like I
literally have a function called Draw
that does this thing but I can think
about implementing draw in a somewhat
different way that's kind of clever and
it's not strictly necessary for this
problem because this problem honestly is
not that complicated to solve once you
have practice under your belt certainly
the first time around probably
significantly challenging but now that
you kind of associate okay Row one with
one brick row two with two bricks it
kind of comes together with these for
Loops but how else could we think about
this problem well this physical
structure these bricks in some sense is
a recursive structure a structure that's
defined in terms of itself now what do I
mean by that well if I were to ask you
the question what is what does a pyramid
of height 4 look like you would point of
course to this picture but you could
also kind of
um
you know cleverly say to me well it's
actually a pyramid of height three plus
one additional row and here's that
cyclical argument right kind of
obnoxious to do typically in English or
in a spoken language because you're
defining one thing in terms of itself
what's a pyramid of height four well
it's a pyramid of whoops it's a pyramid
of height three plus one more row but we
can kind of Leverage this logic and code
well what's a pyramid of height three
well it's a pyramid of high two plus one
more row fine what's a pyramid of height
two well it's a pyramid of height one
plus one more row and then hopefully
this process ends and it does because
notice the pyramid is getting smaller
and smaller so you're not going to sort
of have this sort of silly back and
forth with me infinitely many times
because when we finally get to the base
case the end of the pyramid fine what is
a pyramid of height one well it's a
pyramid of no height plus one more row
and at that point things just get
Negative no pun intended things just
would otherwise go negative and so you
can just kind of stop the base case is
when there is no more pyramid so there's
a way to sort of draw a line in the sand
and say stop no more arguments but this
idea of defining a physical structure in
terms of itself or code in terms of
itself actually lets us do some
interesting new algorithms let me go
back to my code here let me go ahead and
create one final file here called
recursion.c that leverages this idea of
this built-in
self-referential nature let me include
cs50.h let me go ahead and include
standard io.h int main void and then
inside of main I'm going to do the exact
same thing int height equals get int
asking the user for height and then I'm
going to go ahead and call draw passing
in height so that's going to stay the
same I even am going to make my
prototype the same void draw int and
semicolon and now I'm going to implement
void down here with that same prototype
of course but the code now is going to
be a little different
what am I going to do here well first of
all if you ask me to draw a pyramid of
height n I'm going to be kind of a you
know wise ass here and say well just
draw a pyramid of n minus 1. done all
right but there's still a little more
work to be done what happens after I
print or draw a pyramid of height n
minus one according to our structural
definition a moment ago
what remains after drawing a pyramid of
height n minus one or three specifically
we need one more row of hashes okay so I
can do that right I'm okay with the
single Loops there's no nesting
necessary here I'm just going to do this
four int I get zero I is less than n
which is the height that's passed in I
plus plus and then inside of this Loop
I'm very simply going to print out a
single hash and then down here I'm going
to print out a new line at the very end
so that's good right I might not be as
comfortable with nested Loops this is
nice and simple what does this Loop do
here on line 17 through 20 it literally
prints n hashes by counting from I
equals zero on up two but not through n
so that's sort of week one style syntax
but this is kind of trippy now because
I've somehow boiled down the
implementation of draw into printing a
row after just drawing the thing above
it but this is problematic as is because
in this case my draw function notice is
always going to call the draw function
forever in some sense but ideally when
do I want this cyclical process to stop
when do I want to not call draw anymore
yeah
when n is one right when I get to the
top of the pyramid when n is one or heck
when the pyramid is all gone and n
equals zero I can pick any Line in the
Sand so long as it's sort of at the end
of the process then I don't want to call
draw anymore so maybe what I should do
is this if
if n equals equals zero there's really
nothing to draw so I'm just going to go
ahead and return
like this otherwise I'm going to go
ahead and Draw
N minus 1 rows and then one more row and
I could express this differently I could
do something like this which would be
equivalent I could say something like if
n is greater than or equal to zero then
go ahead and draw the row but I like it
this way first for now I'm going to go
with the original way just to ask a
simple question and then just bail out
of the function if n equals 0 and heck
just to be super safe just in case the
user types in a negative number let me
also just check if N is a negative
number also just return immediately
don't do anything I'm not returning a
value because again the function is void
it doesn't need or have a return value
so just saying return suffices but if n
equals one or two or three or anything
higher it is reasonable to draw a
pyramid of slightly shorter height like
instead of four three and then go ahead
and print one more row so this is an
example now of code that calls itself
within itself draw is calling draw but
this so-called base case ensures this
conditional ensures that we're not going
to do this forever otherwise we
literally would do this infinitely many
times and something bad is probably
going to happen
all right let me go ahead and compile
this code make recursion
okay no syntax errors dot slash
recursion enter height of 4 and
voila if only because some of you have
run into this issue accidentally already
let me get rid of the base case here and
let me recompile the code make recursion
oh and actually now it's actually
catching it so the compiler is smart
enough here to realize that
all passed through this function will
call itself AKA it's going to Loop
forever so let me do the first thing
suppose I only check for n equaling 0.
let me go ahead and recompile this code
with make recursion
and now let me just be kind of
uncooperative when I run this program
still works for four still works for
zero what if I do like negative 100
have any of you experienced a
segmentation fault or core dump okay so
no shame in this like this means I have
somehow touched memory that I shouldn't
have and in short I actually called this
function thousands of times accidentally
it would seem now until the program just
bailed on me because I eventually
touched memory in the computer that I
shouldn't have that'll make even more
sense next week but for now it's simply
a bug and I can avoid that bug in this
context probably not your own pset
context by just making sure we don't
even allow for negative numbers at all
so with this building block in place
what can we now do in terms of those
same numbers to sort well it turns out
there's a sorting algorithm called merge
sort and there's Bunches of others too
but merge sort is a nice one to discuss
because it fundamentally I we hope is
going to do better than selection sword
and bubble sort that is better than N
squared
but the cats is it's a little harder to
think about in fact I'll act it out
myself with just these numbers on the
Shelf here rather than humans because
recursion in general takes a little bit
of effort to wrap your mind around
typically a bit of practice but I'll see
if we can't walk through it methodically
enough such that this comes to light so
here's the pseudo code I propose for
this algorithm called merge sort in the
spirit of recursion this sorting
algorithm literally calls itself by
using the verb sort in its pseudo code
so how does merge sort work it sort of
obnoxiously says well if you want to
sort all of these things go sort the
left half then go sort the right half
and then merge the two together now
obnoxious in what sense well if I just
asked you to sort something and you just
tell me we'll go sort that thing and
then go sort that thing what was the
point of asking you in the first place
but the key is that each of these lines
is sorting a smaller piece of the
problem So eventually we'll be able to
Pare this down into something that
doesn't go on forever because in fact in
merge sort there's a base case two
there's a scenario where we just check
wait a minute if there's only one number
to sort that's it quit then because
you're all done so there has to be this
base case in any use of recursion to
make sure that you don't mindlessly call
yourself forever you've got to stop at
some point
so let's focus on the third of these
steps what does it mean to merge two
lists uh two halves on the list just
because this is apparently going to be a
key ingredient so here for instance are
two halves of a list of size eight we
have the numbers two and I'll call it
out if you're at a bad angle two four
five seven and zero one three six notice
that the left half at the moment two
four five seven is already sorted and
the right half zero one three six is
also sorted as well so that's a good
thing because it means that
theoretically I've sorted the left half
already I've sorted the right half
already before we began I just need to
merge these two halves what does it mean
to sort two halves well for the sake of
discussion I'm just going to turn over
most of the numbers except for the first
numbers in each of these halves there's
two halves here left and right at the
moment I'm only going to consider the
leftmost element of each half that is
the one on the left here and the one on
the left here how do I merge these two
lists together well if I look at two and
I look at zero which one should
presumably come first the smaller one so
I'm going to grab the zero and I'm going
to put it into its own place on this new
shelf here and now I'm going to consider
as part of my
iteration
the beginning of this list and the new
beginning of this list so I'm now
comparing two and one which one's
smaller I'm going to go ahead and grab
the one now I'm going to compare the
beginning of the left list and the new
beginning of the right list two and
three of course it's two
now I'm going to compare the beginning
of the left list and the beginning of
the right list four and three it's of
course three
[Music]
now I'm going to compare the four
against the beginning and end it turns
out of the second list four of course
now I'm going to compare the beginning
of the less list and the beginning of
the right list five of course
I'm realizing this does not gonna this
is not gonna end well because I left too
much distance between the numbers but
that has nothing to do with the
algorithm 7 is the beginning of the left
list six is the beginning of the right
list it's of course six and at the risk
of knocking all of these over
if I now make room for this element
we have hopefully
sorted the whole thing by having merged
together the two halves of the list so
in short thank you
I'm a little worried that's just getting
sarcastic now but now we have
we now have merged two have lists we
haven't done the guts of the pro of the
algorithm yet sort the left half and
sort the right half but I claim that
that is how mechanically you merge two
sworded halves you keep looking at the
beginning of each list and you just kind
of weave them together based on which
one belongs first based on its size so
if you agree that that was a reasonable
way to merge two lists together let's go
ahead and focus lastly on what it means
to actually sort the left half and sort
the right half of a whole bunch of
numbers and for this I'm going to go
ahead and order them in this seemingly
random order and I just have a little
cheat sheet above so that I don't mess
up and I'm going to start at the very
top this time and hopefully these will
not fall down at any point but I'm just
deliberately putting them in this random
order
5274 and then we have one six three zero
one six
3-0 hopefully this won't fall over
here is now a array of size eight with
eight integers and I want to sort this I
could use selection sort and just go
back and forth and back and forth I
could use bubble sort and just compare
pairs pairs pairs but those are going to
be on the order of Big O of N squared my
hope is to do fundamentally better here
so let's see if we can do better all
right so let me look now at my code I'll
keep it on the screen
how do I Implement merge sort well if
there's only one number I quit there's
obviously not there's eight numbers so
that's not applicable I'm going to go
ahead and sort the left half of numbers
all right here's the left half five two
seven four how do I sort an array of
size four
well here's where we the recursion kicks
in how do you sort a list of size four
well there's the pseudo code on the
board I sort the left half of the of the
list of size four so here we go
I have a list of size four how do I sort
it I sort the left half all right now I
have a list of size two how do I sort
this
well sort the left half so here we go
here's a list of size one how do I sort
this
oh I think it's done right that's quit
right if only one number I'm done the
five is sorted all right what was the
next step you have to now rewind in time
I just sorted the left half of the left
half of the left half what do I now sort
the right half
which is two this is one Element so I'm
done so now at this point in the story I
have sorted sort of idiotically the five
is sorted and the two is sorted but
what's the third and final step of this
phase of the algorithm
merge the two together so here's the
left here's the right list how do I
merge these together I compare the lists
and I put the two there I only have the
file left and I do that so now we see
some visible progress but again let's
rewind how did we get here we started to
sort the left half of the left half of
the left half then the right half and
now where are we we've just sorted the
left half of the left half
so what comes after sorting the left
half of anything
right half all right here's the sort of
same nonsensical thing here's a list of
size two let's sort the left half done
let's sort the right half done what's
the third step merge them together so
that's the four and that's the seven
what have I now done in total I've now
sorted the left half
of the original thing so what happens
next
wait a minute wait a minute I have not
done that what have I done I have sorted
the left half of the left half and I've
sorted the right half of the left half
what do I now need to do lastly merge
those two lists together so again I put
my finger on the beginning of this list
the beginning of this list and if you
want I'll do the same thing when I
merged last time to be clear what I'm
comparing two and four the two obviously
comes first what comes next
well the four comes next what comes next
the five comes next and then lastly of
course the seven notice that the two
four five seven are now sorted so the
original left half is sorted and I'll do
the rest a little faster because my God
this feels like it takes forever but I
bet we're on to something here what step
remains next I've just sorted the left
half of the original sort the right half
of the original how do I sort this I
sort the left half of the right half how
do I sort this I sort the left half of
the left half done I sort the right half
of the left half done now I merge the
two together the one comes first the six
comes next now I sort the right half of
the right half
what do I do sort the left half done
sort the right half done what do I do
merge them together so that's the third
step of that phase now where are we in
the store oh my God where are we in the
story we have sorted the raw left half
of the right half and the right half of
the right half what comes next merge so
I'm going to compare and I'm going to
move those down just to make clear what
I'm comparing the beginning of both sub
lists what comes first of course the
zero what comes next
what comes next uh the one
what comes next the three
and then lastly comes the six all right
where are we in the story we've now
sorted the left half of the original and
the right half of the original what step
remains
merge all right so I'm gonna make the
same point and this is actually
literally what we did earlier because I
deliberately demoed those original
numbers in this order two and a zero
this comes out first what comes next two
and one the one comes out next what
comes next the two comes next what comes
next the three comes next what comes
next the
four
what comes after that the five
what comes after that the six and lastly
this is when we run out of memory the
seven over there is actually in place
okay
okay so admittedly a little harder to
explain and honestly gets a little
trippy because it's so easy to forget
about like where you are in the story
because we're constantly like diving
into the algorithm and then backing back
out of it but in code we could express
this pretty correctly and it turns out
pretty efficiently because what I was
doing even though it's longer when I do
it verbally I was touching these
elements a minimal amount of times right
I wasn't going back and forth back and
forth in front of the Shelf again and
again I was deliberately only ever
merging the smallest elements in each
list so every time we merged even though
I was doing it quickly my fingers were
only touching each of the elements once
and how many times did we
divide divide divide in half the list
well we started with all of the elements
here and there were eight of them and
then we moved them one two three
positions so the height of this
visualization if you will is actually
log n right if I started with eight
turns out if you do the arithmetic this
is log n height
because 2 to the 3 is 8 but for now just
trust that this is a log n height and
how wide is the Shelf well it's a with n
because there's n elements anytime they
were on the Shelf so technically I was
kind of cheating this algorithm because
this is the first time I've needed
shelves right with the human examples we
just have the humans and that's it and
only eight of them here I was sort of
using more and more memory in fact I was
using like four times as much memory
even though that was just for
visualization's sake merge sort actually
requires that you have some spare space
an empty array to move the elements into
when you're merging them together but if
I really wanted and if I didn't have
this shelf or this shelf honestly I
could have just gone back and forth
between the two shelves that would have
been sufficient so merge sort uses more
memory for this merging process but the
advantage of using more memory is that
the total running time if you can
perhaps infer from that math is what the
Big O notation for merge sort it turns
out is actually going to be n Times log
n and even if you're a little rusty
still on your logarithms we saw in week
zero and again today that log n is
smaller than n right that's a good thing
any binary search was log n that's
faster than linear search which was n so
n Times log n is of course smaller than
n times n or N squared so it's sort of
lower on this little cheat sheet that
I've been drawing which is to suggest
that its running time is indeed better
or faster and in fact if we consider the
best case running time turns out it's
not quite as good as bubble sore with
Omega of n where you can just sort of
abort if you realize wait a minute I've
done no work merge sort you actually
have to do that work to get to the
Finish Line anyway so it's actually in
Omega and ultimately Theta of n log n as
well so again a trade-off there because
if you happen to have a data set that is
very often sorted honestly you might
want to stick with bubble sort but in
the general case where the data is
unsorted n log n is sounding better than
N squared well what does it actually
look or feel like give me a moment to
just change over to our visualization
here and we'll see with this example
what merge sort looks like depicted
within now these vertical bars so same
algorithm but instead of my numbers on
shelves here is a random array of
numbers being sorted
and you can see it being done half at a
time and you see sort of remnants of
algorithm of the previous bars
actually that was unfair let me zoom out
here
let me zoom out so you can actually see
the height here
let me go ahead and randomize this again
and run merge sort there we go now you
can see the second array
and where the values are going
temporarily
and even though this one looks way more
cryptic visualization wise it does seem
to be moving faster and it seems to be
merging halves together and boom it's
done let's actually see in conclusion
what these algorithms compare to and
consider that moving forward as we write
more and more code the goal is again not
just to be correct but to be well
designed and one measure of design is
going to indeed be efficiency so here we
have in final a visualization of three
algorithms selection sort bubble sort
and merge sort from top to bottom and
let's see what these algorithms might
look or sound like here if we can dim
the lights for dramatic effect
selections on top bubble on bottom merge
in the middle
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
well this is cs50 and already this is
week four and recall that last week week
three we began to explore like the
inside of a computer's memory a bit more
we talked about arrays which were just
chunks of memory back to back to back
that really laid things out left to
right top to bottom and this is actually
a pretty common Paradigm even if you're
new to programming and certainly new to
C you've kind of seen this approach of
just using uh memory in some way to lay
things out like images for instance so
for instance here is a photo taken of
last week's front front row for instance
and this is kind of an opportunity to
explore exactly what happens if we start
to zoom in and zoom in and zoom in
because it seems like most any TV show
like CSI whatever or any movie that
explores forensic information might have
the investigators sort of zoom in on an
image like this to see what the glint in
someone's eye is because that reveals
like the license plate number of someone
that just drove past right something
that's a little over the top there but
there's an opportunity here to speak to
why that is so unrealistic for instance
let's zoom on this puppet here's eye and
let's zoom in a little more to see what
might be reflected let's zoom in a
little more and that's it there's only
finite amount of information if you have
an image represented in this way using
pixels these dots on the screen is rows
and columns because if you're only using
a finite amount of memory then at the
end of the day you can only store a
finite amount of information and at
least I don't really see in this grid
here any glint of a license plate or
something like that that you might
otherwise see in in Hollywood so today
we'll explore sort of these kinds of
representations of how you might use
memory in new and interesting ways to
represent now very familiar things but
also start to explore what some of the
limitations are of this representation
but consider after all that this doesn't
need to be even as high resolution as
many pixels as something like this other
image you can imagine just doing
something silly with Post-it notes like
this and if you think of an image it's
just having rows and columns these rows
otherwise known as scan lines something
looks floor in the coming week you could
make this sort of fun smiley face by
just using two different values maybe a
zero and a one or yellow in purple or
vice versa just to kind of make
something come to life now in practice
recall we talked about storing not just
a zero or one but maybe an r a g and a b
value like 24 bits or three uh bytes in
total but we'll come back to that that
would just be a more involved image but
if for fun if today you sort of want to
um
tackle something passively in the
background if you go to uh this URL here
we've put together an opportunity to do
a sort of a bit of pixel art if you go
to this URL here that'll redirect you to
a Google spreadsheet if you have a
laptop with you today that'll look a
little something like this which we've
sort of organized in rows and columns so
if you'd like to go ahead and use Google
spreadsheets colorization fill feature
to color in those individual squares if
you'd like to see if you can't make
something a little creative and then
email it to Carter and we'll exhibit
some of the the best or favorites on the
website thereafter so let's transition
then to something a little more familiar
images and not all of you have used
presumably Photoshop but you're probably
generally familiar with Photoshop as a
program for editing and creating images
or photos or the like and here is a
screenshot of photoshop's Color Picker
via which you can change like what color
you're going to draw with the paintbrush
or what color you're going to fill in
with the the paint buckets it's
representative of any kind of graphical
tool and there's kind of a lot of
information in here but there's perhaps
some familiar terms now r g and B in
fact right now this is a photoshop's way
of saying you're about to fill in your
background or foreground with the color
black and that appears to be represented
with an r a g and a b value of zero zero
zero or alternatively using a hash
symbol and then zero zero zero zero zero
zero and if some of you have already
made web pages before and you know a
little bit of HTML and CSS you probably
are familiar with this kind of syntax
like a hash symbol and then six or
sometimes three digits thereafter and if
we look at a few different colors here
for instance here might be the
representation of white now the r the G
and the B values went way up from 0 to
255 255 255 or alternatively it looks
like Photoshop and in turn web browsers
could represent that same color white
with ffff and let's just do a few others
here is red and it turns out that red is
a whole lot of red 255 but no green no
blue or AKA
ff000 so there's perhaps a pattern here
emerging here is green 0 255 0
aka00ff00 or lastly here blue which is
no red no green but apparently a lot of
blue 255 again AKA zero zero zero zero
FF now some of you again might have seen
these this notation before these zeros
in these F's and all of the numbers and
letters in between but this is another
form of notation and in fact we'll
explore this today really is just a
precondition for talking about some
other Concepts but the idea is
ultimately are really no different what
we're about to see is a different base
system not just binary not just decimal
but something we're about to call
hexadecimal but first recall that with
RGB we previously did that we did the
following any RGB value red green blue
just combines some amount of red or
green or blue so here we have 72 73 33
which in the context of an email or a
text of course said
what a couple weeks back
just high with an exclamation point but
in the context of a Photoshop like
program this might instead be
representing collectively this shade of
yellow for instance when you combine
that much red that much green that much
blue so here is the same idea if you've
got a lot of red no green no blue
together that's going to give us red if
you've got no red a lot of green no blue
that's going to give us of course green
if you've got no red no green a lot of
blue that of course is going to give us
blue so there's a pattern emerging here
where apparently 0 0 is none as always
and FF is apparently a lot and it's
maybe somehow equated with 255 at least
per that photoshop screenshot meanwhile
if we combine one last one a lot of red
a lot of green a lot of blue that's
actually going to give us a single white
pixel like this all right so think back
here was binary in the world of binary
you had just two digits zero and one
could have been anything else A or B X
or Y but the world standardized on these
uh uh numerals zero and one and our
world's Decimal System of course you
have zero through nine as of today
though we're going to start using
hexadecimal sometimes in the context of
images and also files just because it's
a convention there's some conveniences
to it where now you're going to be able
to count up to f in a notation called
hexadecimal from zero through nine then
you keep going to A to B to C to D to e
to F the idea being each of these even
though it's weirdly a letter of the
English alphabet it's still just a
single symbol it's not 1 0 for 10 or 1 1
for 11 all 16 of these values these
digits so to speak are indeed still just
single symbols and that's a
characteristic of just using this other
notational system so how do we get from
zero zero uh and FF to something like
zero and 255 respectively well this
hexadecimal system AKA base 16 just does
the math from week zero and really grade
school a little bit differently for
instance if you have a number that's got
two digits or hexadecimal digits as of
today the columns are just a little
different instead of powers of two or
powers of 10 which we solve for binary
and decimal respectively its powers of
16. so if we just kind of do the math
out that's the ones column this is the
16s column and so forth things get
actually pretty big pretty quickly and
this system but now let's just consider
how we would represent familiar numbers
if you've got two hexadecimal digits for
which these hashes are just placeholders
0 0 is going to mathematically equal the
decimal number you and I know of course
as zero why same thing as week zero
sixteen times zero plus one times zero
is the number you and I know is zero and
we can count up from here this in
hexadecimal would be how a computer
represents the number we know is one it
would be zero one in this case this
would be two three four five six seven
eight nine in decimal we're about to go
to ten but in hexadecimal to be clear
what comes next
so apparently a so 0 a 0b which is now
10 or 11 or 12 13 14 15. so using
hexadecimal is just kind of an
interesting way of using single symbols
now zero through F to count from 0
through 15 and we'll see why it's 15 in
a moment but as soon as we get to F
anyone want to conjuncture how in
hexadecimal AKA hex do we now count up
one position higher what comes after
zero f in hexadecimal
so one zero it's the same kind of thing
like once you're at the highest digit
possible F or in our decimal world it
would have been nine you sort of add one
more and nine wraps around to zero or in
this case f reps around to zero you
carry the one and voila now we're
representing the number U and I know is
16 and we should keep going forever
literally this could be 17 18 19 20 in
decimal but let's just wave our hands at
it and count as high as we can dot dot
dot the highest we could count in
hexadecimal with two digits just
logically would be what in hexadecimal
something something
FF I heard so yes that's the biggest
digit possible so FF is what we have so
how high can you count in hexadecimal if
you've got just two of these digits well
it's the same math as always 16 times F
AKA 15. so that's 16 times 15 plus 1
times F or 1 times 15. that gives us 240
plus 15 in decimal the result of which
of course now is 255.
so this hexadecimal system you may have
seen in the world of web pages and if
you haven't we'll get to that in this
class in a few weeks or we just saw in
the context of Photoshop just has this
sort of shorthand notation of counting
as high as 255 but just calling it FF
now it's marginal but that's like 50
Savings of how many digits you need in
order to count as high as 255 because in
decimal of course 255 is three digits in
hexadecimal you can count as high using
just two and that difference is going to
get magnified the bigger our numbers get
let me stipulate for now you're going to
get more and more Savings in terms of
just how many symbols you need on the
screen to represent
bigger and bigger numbers than that all
right let me pause here just to see if
there's any questions thus far on what
we've called hexadecimal which again
just gives us zero through nine as well
as a
through f
any questions or confusion
and if it feels like we're lingering a
bit much on arithmetic we're not really
going to see other notations besides
this moving forward these are sort of
the go-to three in a programmer's world
typically
but there are some others yeah
good question does hexadecimal require
more storage or less storage than a
decimal system theoretically no because
this is just a way of representing
information and we'll see in a concrete
example in a moment but inside of the
computer at the end of the day you're
still storing bits and using
hexadecimals not using more or fewer
bits think of this as how you might
write it down on a piece of paper just
how many digits you're going to write or
on a computer screen how many digits
you're going to see at once but it
doesn't change how many how the
computers representing information
because all they're representing at the
end of the day is zeros and ones so in
fact let's go there if this a moment ago
FF I claim was 255 let's just rewind to
week zero and if we wanted to count to
255 in binary that's as high as you can
count recall with eight bits and there's
only a few of these numbers that are
useful to memorize like 255 is as high
as you can count with eight bits if you
start at zero because two to the eighth
is 256 but if you start at zero it's
zero through 255. so in binary recall if
you have eight bits all of which were
ones and I won't do out the math
pedantically here but if I do do this
plus this plus this dot dot that's also
going to give me 255. so this is what's
interesting here about hexadecimal it
turns out that in upside of storing
values in hexadecimal is that we're
going to see the first F sort of
represents the left half of all these
bits and the second F in this case
represents the right most four of these
bits so it turns out hexadecimal is very
useful when you want to treat data in
units of four it's not quite eight but
units of four and that's not bad which
is why if you use two digits like I have
thus far zero zero or FF or anything in
between that's actually a convenient way
of representing eight bits in total one
hexade for the first four bits one hex
digit for the second and again there's
nothing new intellectually here per se
it's just a different way of
representing the same story as before
zeros and ones so in what context do we
see this well we talked about memory
last week we're going to talk more about
it this week if this is my computer's
Ram Random Access Memory you can again
think of each byte as having a number
associated with it like it's a dress or
location this might be zero this might
be like 2 billion and so in the past
I've described these as just this using
decimal numbers here's byte zero one two
three four five six seven fifteen
sixteen would be here and so forth but
it turns out in the world of memory and
thus today programming people tend to
count memory bytes using hexadecimal
partly just by convention but also
partly because it's a little more
succinct and again each digit represents
four bits typically so what comes after
F here well if I think about the
computer's memory I normally might do
after F which is 15 16 but instead one
zero one one one two one three this is
not 10 11 12 13 because I claim I'm in
the context of hexadecimal now as per
the previous slide we already started
going into A's through F's so you
immediately see here a possible problem
like why is this now worrisome if all of
a sudden you're seeing seemingly
familiar numbers like ones 10 11 12 13.
we didn't really stumble off across this
problem when it was like all zeros and
ones before yeah
yeah so if you're writing some code in C
that's doing some math you might
accidentally or the computer might
accidentally confuse hexadecimal with
decimal if they look in some context the
same I mean any number on the board that
doesn't have a letter is Ambiguously
hexadecimal or decimal at this point and
so how might we resolve this well it
turns out that what computers typically
do is this by convention anytime you see
visually 0x and then a number that's a
human Convention of saying signaling to
the reader that this is in fact a
hexadecimal number so if it's 0x 1 0
that is not the number 10 that is the
hexadecimal number one zero which recall
we said earlier is how you count up to
16 and again and again these are not the
kinds of things to memorize it's really
just the system for how you think about
these things so hence for today we're
going to start seeing hexadecimal in a
bunch of contexts when you write code
you might even write code using some
hexadecimal but again it's just a
different way of representing numbers
and humans have different conventions
for different contexts
all right so with that said any
questions now on this building block but
here on out we'll start using it in some
actual code
any questions nothing so far all right
so let's go ahead and consider maybe a
familiar example something where
involving code where I initialize a
variable like n to a value like 50 in
this case and then let's start to Tinker
around with what's going on inside of
the computer's memory in a moment I'm
going to load up vs code on my computer
and I'm going to go ahead and whip up a
program that very simply assigns a value
like the number 50 to a variable called
n but today keep in mind that that
variable n and that value 50 is going to
be stored somewhere in my computer's
memory and it turns out today we'll
introduce a bit more syntax you can
actually see where things are being
stored so let me click over to BS code
here I'm going to create a program
called address dot C just to explore
computers addresses today and I'm going
to do an include standard io.h int main
void as usual no command line Arguments
for now I'm going to declare that
variable n equals 50. and then I'm just
going to go ahead and print it out so
nothing very interesting but I'll use
percent I backslash n and then comma n
to print out that value nothing here
should be very interesting to compile or
run but I'll do it just to make sure I
didn't make any mistakes looks like as
expected it simply prints out the number
zero 50 like this but let's consider
then what this code is doing underneath
the hood when it's actually run on your
machine so here we have that grid of
memory that variable n is an INT and if
you think back how many bytes typically
do we use for an INT
yeah
four so four bytes or 32 bits so if each
of these squares represents one byte
then my computer Somewhere In My Memory
or Ram is using four of these squares
maybe it ends up over here just because
there's other stuff being used Elsewhere
for instance though I don't really know
and frankly I don't really care where it
ends up just that it ends up somewhere
so the variable the value 50 is stored
here in a variable called n even though
I've written it as decimal just like in
my code let me again remind that this is
32 zeros and ones representing that 50
it's just going to be very tedious if we
start writing everything in binary so
I'll use the more comfortable human
Decimal System so that's what's going on
inside of the computer's memory so what
if I actually wanted to start tinkering
with its location or maybe just knowing
its location well this variable n indeed
has a name n that's a label of sorts for
it but at the end of the day that 50 is
technically at a specific address and
I'm going to make one up
0x123 and it's one two three because I
really don't care what it is just want
an address for the sake of discussion so
way over here off screen might be byte
zero way down here is byte Ox one two
three it's in hexadecimal notation just
by convention
so how can I actually see where my
variables are ending up in memory if I'm
curious to do so well let me go back to
my code here and let me actually change
this just a little bit let me go ahead
and introduce for instance another
symbol here and another topic altogether
namely pointers
so a pointer is a variable that stores
the address of some value the location
of some value or more specifically the
specific byte in which that value is
stored so again if you think of your
memory as being a whole bunch of bytes
zero at top left two billion or whatever
at bottom right depending on how much
RAM you have each of those things has a
location in our address a pointer is
just a variable storing one such address
so it turns out that in the world of C
there's a couple of new symbols we can
use if we want to see what it is we're
talking about here and those two
operators as of today are these you can
use the Ampersand operator in C in a
couple of ways we already saw it very
briefly to do Ampersand Ampersand to
kind of and to con to Boolean
Expressions together in the context of a
conditional this is different a single
Ampersand is the address of operator so
literally in your code if you've got a
variable like n or anything else and you
write Ampersand n c is going to figure
out for you what is the address of that
variable n in the computer's memory and
it's going to give you a number a a
number the otherwise known as the
address of that
if you want to store that address in a
variable even though yes it's a number
like ox123 you have to tell C in advance
that you want to store not an INT per se
but the address of an INT and the Syntax
for doing that somewhat not obviously is
to use an asterisk here a star operator
and you say this when creating a
variable if you want P to be a pointer
that is the address of some other
variable you do int star p and the star
just tells the computer this is not an
integer per se this is the address of
something that yes is an INT but we're
just being more precise so on the right
hand side you have the address of
operator as always with the equal sign
you copy from right to left because
Ampersand n is by definition the address
of something you have to store it in a
pointer and the way to declare a pointer
is to specify the type of value whose
address you're storing and then use the
star to indicate that this isn't a
pointer and not just a regular old int
so let's see this in practice let me go
back to my own source code here and let
me make just a couple of tweaks I'm
going to leave n alone here but I'm
going to go ahead and initially
just do this uh let me say int star P
equals Ampersand n and then down here
I'm going to print out not end this time
but P the variable p and then even
though yes it's just a number and
therefore I kind of sort of could use
percent I for integers there's actually
a special format code in printf for
printing pointers or addresses and
that's percent p
so now let's go ahead and recompile this
make address so far so good dot slash
address enter and a little weirdly but
perhaps understandably now the address
in my computer's memory at which the
variable n happened to be stored was not
quite as simple as ox123 this computer
has a lot more memory so technically it
was stored at Ox
7ffcb4578e5c now that has no special
significance to me it could have ended
up somewhere else altogether but this is
just where in my computer or technically
the Cloud Server to which I'm connected
using vs code here that just happens to
be where n ended up and strictly
speaking I don't even need to introduce
this variable I could get rid of p and I
could just say print not just n but the
address of N and achieve the same thing
you don't need to temporarily store it
in a variable let me just do make
address again dot slash address and now
I see this address here and notice if I
keep running the program it's actually
moving around there's other stuff
presumably going on inside of the
computer maybe it's actually randomizing
it so it's not always at the same
location that can actually be a security
feature underneath the hood but this
happens to be at that moment in time
where that value is in memory quite like
our picture a moment ago all right so
let me pause here to see if there's now
any questions on what we just did yeah
really good question is there any way to
control where something is in memory
short answer is yes and this is both the
power and the danger of c and we're
going to do this today and make a few
deliberate mistakes because with this
power of going to or getting the address
of any variable I could just arbitrarily
right now write code that stores a value
like byte 2 billion or zero or anything
in between but that also means
potentially I could start kind of
creepily looking around at all of the
computer's memory even at things that I
didn't put there maybe other programs
maybe other parts of programs and indeed
this is a potential security threat if
suddenly you're able to just look
anywhere you want in the computer's
memory now I'm overselling it a little
bit because nowadays in this decade
there are some defenses in place in
compilers and in our operating systems
that do hedge against this a little bit
but this is still a very frequent source
of problems and later today we'll talk
briefly about of things called stack
Overflow which is not just a website it
is a problem that you can encounter Heap
overflow and more generally buffer
overflows there's just so many things
that can go wrong using this language
called C and if any of you have
encountered a segmentation fault yet I
think we saw a few hands for that
already you touched memory that you
shouldn't have and odds are you did it
most recently by going too far in an
array going to the left or negative in
an array or somehow looking at memory
you shouldn't have and we'll explain
today why it is you were able to do that
other questions on these Primitives so
far yeah from Carter
good question earlier we used star P let
me rewind in time to the previous
version of this code where I actually
had a variable called P just like with
variable declarations in the past once
you've declared a variable to be an INT
a Char a bull or an in Star AKA a
pointer you don't thereafter keep using
the word int or now the star once you've
declared it that's it you only refer to
it by name and so it's very deliberate
what I did here name
saying that the type here is in star
that is a pointer to an INT but here I
just said the name of the variable as
always I didn't repeat int and I also
didn't repeat star but at the risk of
kind of bending one's Minds a little bit
there is unfortunately one other use for
the star operator and that's as follows
if you want to print out not the address
of something but what is at a specific
address you can actually do this if I
want to print out the integer via
percent I that is at that address I can
actually use the star here which
technically contradicts what I just said
but it has a different function here
different purpose so let me go ahead and
do this in two different ways I'm going
to leave this line of code AS is but I'm
going to add another line of code now
that prints out what apparently will be
an integer in a moment
so percent I backslash n and I could
cheat and let me just do n for now so
there's really nothing special happening
now I'm just adding a sort of mindless
printing of n so make address dot slash
address there's the current address
event and there's the value of n but
what's kind of cool about C here too is
if you know that a value is at a
specific address like P there's one
other use for this star operator the
asterisk you can use it as these are
called dereference operator which means
go to that address and so here what we
actually have is an example of a pointer
P which is an address like ox123 or ox7
FF and so forth but if you say star P
now you're not redeclaring the variable
because I didn't mention int you're
going to that address in P so let me
recompile this now make
um make a dress
dot slash address and just to be clear
what should I see I'm first going to see
the pointer itself Ox something what's
the second line of output I should
presumably see now
just add a little louder
so I'm hearing 50 and that's true
because if you figure out the address of
n
and print it in line seven but then go
to the address of n AKA P that's indeed
going to just show you the number n the
value of n again
or any questions now on this syntax and
I will concede I think this is confusing
the fact that we use the star for
multiplication the fact that we use the
star to declare a pointer but then we
use a star and a third way to
de-reference the pointer and go to the
pointer it's just confusing honestly but
with practice comes Comfort yeah
good question do you when you are using
the uh the Ampersand operator to get the
address of something the onus is on you
at the moment to know what you are
getting the address of is it a string is
it a Char is it a bull is it an INT I
wrote this code so I know in line six
that I'm trying to get the address of
what is an integer
in line eight you don't have to worry
about that good question notice in line
eight I didn't tell the computer other
than the percent I what kind of address
I'm going to but I did already in line
six I told the compiler that P now and
forever is going to be the address of an
INT that's enough information in advance
so that printf or really the language C
still knows on line 8 that P is a
pointer to an INT and that way it will
print out all four bytes at that address
not just part of it and not more than
those four bytes good question yeah next
to you
do pointers have pointers yes we won't
um sort of do this today by having
pointers to pointers but yes you can use
star star and then things get and I'm
sorry
we won't do that today and we won't do
that often in fact Python and other
languages just a couple of weeks away so
hang in there almost there a question
back here
was there
that was a good more verbal feedback
like that is helpful as we Forge it's a
more complicated stuff other questions
yeah
what's the point of printing the address
like
sure what's the point of doing this if
you don't mind let me let's get there in
a moment this is not the common use case
just printing out the address like who
really cares at the moment we care only
for the sake of discussion we're soon
going to start using these addresses so
hang in there just a little bit for that
one too but it will uh solve some
problems for us before long so let's
actually just now depict what was going
on inside of the computer's memory just
a moment ago so if I toggle back here
let me redraw my computer's memory let
me plop into the memory n which is
storing in this program the number 50
where is p in my computer's memory
specifically I don't know and apparently
it moves around each time I run the
program so for the sake of discussion
let's just propose that if 50 ended up
at address ox123 I don't know P ends up
over here at address whoops at whatever
address this is here but notice a couple
of Curiosities now if p is a pointer
it's the address of something so the
value in P should be an address and I've
indeed written it as such ox123 and
technically there's not an X there
there's not a zero there there's not
even a one two three there per se
there's a pattern of bits that
represents the address ox123 but again
that's week zero don't care about binary
day to day
so if this is p and this I claimed was n
why is p so much bigger can someone
conjecture here
because it turns out whether n is an INT
or a Char or a bull which are different
types heck even along
it turns out that P is always going to
take up eight squares on the board but
why might that be
What might explain that
thought
okay fair maybe it's allocating eight
bytes because it doesn't know the type
turns out that's okay because it
addresses an address it's really up to
the programmer to use it as a string or
a terrible other thoughts
so you know
okay possibly it could be that pointers
have some complexity like a backslash n
or something curious like that like we
talked about for Strings turns out
that's not the case it turns out that
pointers nowadays typically are but not
always are eight bytes AKA 64-bit
because you and I are Max RPS heck even
our phones have a lot more memory than
they did years ago back in the day a
pointer might have only been 32 bits or
even only eight bits way back in the day
if it's considered 32 bits because that
was the norm for some time how high can
you count roughly if you've got 32 bits
what's the number we keep rattling off
32 bits is roughly
2 to the 32 so it's 4 billion and I keep
saying it's 2 billion if you could do
negative but in the world of memory I
there's a reason I keep saying 2 billion
bytes two gigabytes because for a very
long time that was the maximum amount of
memory a computer could have why because
the pointers that the computers were
using were only for instance 32 bits and
with 32 bits depending on whether you
allow for negatives or not you can count
as high as 2 billion roughly or maybe 4
billion but you know what your Mac your
PC your phone could not have had five
gigabytes of memory or five billion
bytes of memory you certainly couldn't
have had what computers nowadays come
with which might be eight gigabytes of
memory 16 gigabytes of memory y because
with four bytes or 32 bits you literally
physically can't count that high which
means if I drew a picture of all of the
memory we would run out of numbers to
describe them which means like most of
my memory would just be unusable so
pointers nowadays are 64 bits or 8 bytes
that's really big I can't even pronounce
how big that number is but it's plenty
for the next many years and so we've
drawn it that way on the board here now
let's just kind of abstract this away
let's get rid of all the other bites
that are storing something or nothing
else and let's now start to abstract
away this complexity because the reality
is to your question earlier you know
what is this useful for or what do we do
we actually care about these addresses
generally no we're doing this so that
you see there's no magic we're just
moving things around and poking around
in memory but what a person would
typically do when talking about pointers
would literally be to just point at
something like I really don't care what
address and is at so it suffices when
General when drawing pictures on a
whiteboard having a discussion with
another programmer you just kind of draw
an arrow from the pointer to the value
in question because neither you nor I
probably care about the specifics of ox
whatever and there's your pointer it's
literally an arrow and we can kind of
see this so it turns out that these
pointers these addresses are not that
dissimilar to what we've done for
hundreds of years in the form of a
postal system for instance here's a post
office here no here is a mailbox and
suppose that this is a mailbox labeled P
it's a pointer and suppose there's
another mailbox like way over there
which is just another byte of my
computer's memory what are we really
talking about well you store in your
computer's memory values like the number
50 or the word like High inside of your
computer's memory at some location but
today we can also use those same memory
locations to store the address of things
for instance if I open this up here and
I see okay the value inside of this
mailbox is not a number like 50. it's
actually an address ox123 that's kind of
like a pointer sort of a breadcrumb
leading from one location in memory to
another and in fact with someone who's
seated roughly over there do you mind
getting the mail over there
any volunteers over in this section
just need you to get to the mailbox
before I do who's who's being
volunteered oh yes please whoever is uh
gesturing wild most wildly
come on down
sure
what's your name
say again
and Foo
okay come on up to the edge of the stage
there and just to be clear if this is P
that is apparently n but to make clear
what we're talking about when we're
storing Ox whatever values like ox123
that's essentially equivalent to my you
know maybe pulling out something like
this and just abstractly pointing to
your mailbox there or if you prefer
pointing to the mailbox okay all right
oh thank you all right
this is akin to me pointing at your
mailbox and if you want to go ahead and
open your mailbox and reveal to the
crowd what's inside your mailbox
labeled n
all right
thank you
we have a little a cs50 stress ball for
your trouble thank you for coming up so
that's just to put a visual on what it
is we're talking about because it can
get very abstract very cryptic quickly
when we're talking about addresses and
memory and drawing it like these little
squares but if you think about just
walking into a post office or an
apartment complex that's got a lot of
mailboxes those mailboxes essentially
are a big chunk of memory and each of
those mailboxes has an address this is
apartment one two three apartment two
billion and inside of those mailboxes
can go anything that can be represented
as information it could be a number like
n or 50 or if you prefer it could be a
number that represents the address of
another mailbox and this is Akin really
if you've ever had an apartment or you
and your parents have moved to having a
forwarding address it's like having the
post office in the U.S put some kind of
piece of paper in your old mailbox
saying actually forward it to that other
mailbox that really is all a pointers
doing at the end of the day it's just a
number but it's a number being used in a
different way and it's the syntax that
we've introduced not just int but in
star that tells the computer how to
treat that number in this slightly
different way are any questions then on
this yeah and back
if I did in C and set it to say the code
again
once more
equal to n so let me actually type it
out if I give myself another line of
code tell me one last time what's a type
int
is equal to n like this
so this is okay and I can't draw it
quite quickly enough on the board here
but this would be like creating another
four bytes somewhere in memory maybe
down here that stores an identical copy
of 50 because the assignment operator
from right to left copies one value to
another so that would just add one more
rectangle of size 4 to this particular
picture
if I'm answering your question as
intended okay so that is sort of sort of
week one style use of assignment
operators before pointers I could though
start copying pointers but again we'll
come back to some of that complexity any
other questions here
ah good question short answer no to
repeat for the camera if I create a
second variable like this in C equals n
and I claim without actually drawing it
on the board that this gives me another
rectangle the value of which is also 50
P does not get touched and this is
what's important and really
characteristic of C nothing happens
automatically for you like not p is not
going to be updated unless you update p
in some way so creating a third variable
called C even if you're copying its
value from right to left that has no
effect on anything else in the program a
good question
so what have we seen that's perhaps now
a little more explainable we'll recall
that we talked quite a bit last week
about strings and just to recap in
layperson's terms like what is a string
as you now understand it
say let me take a specific hand here
what's a string how about uh over here
and okay sure both of you are right an
array of characters an array of
characters and we I claimed or revealed
last week that string is not technically
a feature built into C like it's not an
official data type but every programmer
in most any language refers to sequences
of characters words letters paragraphs
as strings so the vernacular exists but
the data type doesn't typically exist
per se in C so what we're about to do if
you will for dramatic effect is take off
some training wheels today the cs50
library implemented in the form of the
header file cs50.h we claim has had a
bunch of things in it prototypes for get
string prototypes for get int and all of
those other functions but it turns out
it also is what defines the word string
in such a way that you all can use it
these past several weeks so let's take a
look at an example of a string in use
here for instance is a tiny bit of code
that uses the word string creating a
variable called s and then storing quote
unquote High exclamation station Point
Let's consider what this looks like now
in the computer's memory I don't care
about all the other bytes let's just
focus on these and this per last week is
how high might be stored h i exclamation
point and then one more as someone
already observed that Sentinel value
that null character which just means
eight zero bits to demarcate the end of
that string just in case there's
something to the right of it the
computer can now distinguish one string
from another
so last week we introduced this new
syntax well if strings are just arrays
of characters you can then very cleverly
use that square bracket notation and go
to location 0 or 1 or 2 which are kind
of sort of like addresses but they're
relative to the string right this could
be at ox123 or ox456 but with this
bracket notation zero is always the
beginning of the string one is the next
two is the next and so forth so that was
our array syntax for indexing into an
array but technically speaking we can go
a little deeper today technically
speaking if high is starting at the
address ox123 then it stands to reason
that I is at ox124 exclamation points at
ox125 and the the null is at ox126 now I
don't care about one two three per se
but even though this is hexadecimal this
is correct math even in HEX if you just
add one when you start at ox123 the next
number is four five six at the end I
don't have to worry about A's B's into
sees because I'm not counting that high
in this example
so if that's the case and my computer is
actually laying out the word hi in
memory like that well what exactly is s
right what exactly is s if at the end of
the day h i exclamation point null is
storing is are stored at these addresses
like where is s like now that I've kind
of taken off those training wheels and
showed you where h i exclamation point
null actually are what happened to s
well S as always is actually a variable
right even in the code I proposed a
moment ago s is apparently a data type
that yes doesn't come with C but cs50's
Library makes it exist s is a variable
of type string so where is s in this
picture well it turns out that s might
be up here again I'm just drawing it
anywhere for the sake of this discussion
but s is a variable per that line of
code what s is storing apparently I
claim is ox123 I actually don't really
care about these addresses so let's
abstract that away s is apparently as of
now today one week later just a pointer
to a character specifically the first
character in s and this is kind of the
last piece of the puzzle last week we
had this clever way of demarcating the
end of a string well it turns out that
strings are represented in the
computer's memory as a variable that is
a pointer
inside of which is the address of the
first character in the string so if s is
got points at the first character and
you can trust that backslash zero is at
the end of the string that's literally
all you need to figure out where a
string begins and ends so what do I mean
by this well let's be a little more
Concrete in terms of this picture if
I've started with this line of code here
it turns out all this time since week
one that the word string has just
semi-secretely been an alias for
Char star
I know so Char star so why does this
make sense it's a little weird still but
if in our previous example we were able
to store the address of an integer by
declaring a variable called p as in Star
P well if as of now strings are just the
address of the first character in a
string then probably a string is just a
Char star because that means s is the
address of a character the very first
character in the string now the string
might have three letters like it did or
four or even a hundred if it's a long
paragraph but that's fine because you
can trust that there's going to be that
null character at the very end so this
is a general purpose way of representing
strings using this new mechanism in C so
in fact let me go ahead here and
introduce maybe a couple of
manipulations of this let me go back to
my code here and let's get rid of this
integer stuff and let's instead Now do
for instance this let me add in the cs50
library so we'll include cs50.h4 now I'm
going to go ahead and inside of main
give myself a string s equals High
exclamation point I don't type the
backslash zero C does that for me
automatically uh by using my double
quotes like this now let me just go
ahead and print it so this again is sort
of week one style stuff where I'm just
printing a string no pointers yet
so let me do make address enter dot
slash address and hopefully I see high
so nothing new there but let's start to
peel back some of these layers here let
me first of all get rid of the cs50
library for a moment and let me change
string
to char star
and it's a little bit weird but yes the
convention is to say Char a space then
the star and then immediately thereafter
the name of the variable strictly
speaking though you might see textbooks
or websites that do it like this or like
this but the canonical way is typically
to do it like that so now no more cs50
Library no more training wheels if you
will I'm just treating strings for what
they really are let me go ahead and do
make address enter so far so good dot
slash address and that too still works
so percent s is a thing that comes with
printf because the word string is
programmer terminology but strictly
speaking C doesn't have a string data
type it's always been Char star so what
this means now is I can start to kind of
have some fun with these basic ideas
even though this is not purposeful other
than for the sake of discussion but if s
is this let me go back and give myself
the cs50 library let's put those
training wheels back on for just a
moment so that I can do one manipulation
at a time here's my string S as before
well let me go ahead and declare a car
called C and let me store the first
character in the string there which is s
bracket zero and that should give me H
and then Just for kicks let me go ahead
and do Char star whoops let me go ahead
and do Char star P equals Ampersand C
and see what this actually prints for me
let me go ahead and print out what p is
here
so we're just playing around so make a
dress so far so good dot slash address
all right so what have I just done I've
just created a Char C and stored in it
the letter H which is the same thing as
s bracket I then I'm saying what's the
address of c and that's apparently ox7ff
whatever so that's the address but I
technically didn't have to do that let
me go ahead and do two things now
instead of just printing P let me go
ahead and print out maybe s itself
let me go ahead and do make address
enter so far so good dot slash address
and damn it what did I do
oh shoot I didn't want to do that oh I
really made a mess of this
um
what did I want to do here
That was supposed to be impressive but
it was the opposite so let me
turn it around so if I intended to do
this why are not lines nine and ten
printing different values didn't really
intend to go here but let me try to save
this
why are we seeing different addresses
namely this address
402004 for S and then ox7ff for
P any thoughts yeah over here
correct so if I really wanted to weasel
my way out of this this is a great
answer to the previous question which
was about what if I introduce another
variable C that's a copy of the value
and not in this case an INT but an
actual Char here I've made C be a copy
of the character that's at the beginning
of s but that's indeed a copy so if I
were to draw it on the screen that would
give me a different rectangle in which
this copy of H would actually be stored
so I didn't intend to do this but what
you're seeing is yes the address of s
and apparently that's at a pretty low
address by default here then you're
seeing the address of C but even though
each of them is H I claim one is at a
different address in memory and this has
always been happening anytime you
created one variable or another it was
ending up here or here or here or
somewhere else in memory now for the
first time all we're doing is actually
just poking around the computer's memory
to see what is actually there so let me
actually
back this up a little bit and do what I
intended to do here which was something
like this so if string s equals quote
unquote High let's go ahead and give
myself a pointer called P to the first
character in EST
all right so now let me go ahead and
print out the value of this pointer
percent P printing out P so we're just
going to do one thing at a time so make
a dress enter dot slash address there at
the moment is the address of the first
character in s what I meant to do now
was this if I want to print out two
things this time let me print out not
only what p is but also what s itself
originally is because if I claim that
everyone from last week should be
comfortable with s bracket zero just
representing the first character in s by
definition of strings being a rays of
characters
then S as of today is itself the address
of a character the first one in s so if
I now do make a dress
and do dot slash address this time I see
the same exact things thank you
this is really like the lamest sort of
thing to be applauding over but what
we're demonstrating here is that s is by
definition the address of the first
character in C so if we borrow some of
our mental model from last week well if
s bracket zero is the first character in
C doing the Ampersand on that expression
should be the same as s now this isn't
to say that we would kind of jump
through these hoops all the time with
this much syntax but this is just to do
proof by example that s is in fact as I
claimed a moment ago just the address of
a character not even multiple characters
it's the address of a single character
but the key thing is it's the address of
the first character in the string and
per last week we trust that c is going
to look for that null character at the
very end just to make sure it knows
where the string actually ends all right
let's person came up over here
correct to summarize on line eight when
I am using percent P that just means
print a pointer value so Ox something
I'm passing it s
previously when we used percent s printf
new to print not just the first
character of s but h i exclamation point
and then stop when it hits the backslash
zero percent p is different percent P
tells the computer to go to that address
sorry tells the computer to print that
address on the screen
so this is where percent s all this time
has been powerful the reason printf
worked in week one and two and three was
because printf was designed by some
human years ago to go to the address
that's being passed in for instance s
and print out character after character
after character until it sees the null
character backslash zero and then stop
printing it so that's you're getting a
lot of functionality sort of for free
from percent s today we're using
something much simpler percent P which
just literally prints what s is and the
reason we don't do this in week one is
just because this is like way too much
to be interesting when all you want to
print out is high or hello world or the
like but now what we're really doing is
revealing what's been going on this
whole time and let me make one other
example here let me go ahead and get rid
of this variable here and let me just
print out a few things to make this same
point I'm going to print out not just an
S like I did here but let's go ahead and
print out every the address of every
character in s so let's get the first
letter in s and get its address
and I'm going to do copy paste for
time's sake but not something I would do
frequently
so let me print out the address of the
first character the second character the
third and actually even the fourth which
is the backslash Zero by doing this
so when I compile this program make
address
dot slash address I should see two
identical values and then additional
values that are one byte away in my
diagram a moment ago my addresses were
arbitrarily ox123 one two four one two
five one two six now it starts at by
chance Ox
402004 which is s
ox402004 is the same thing as s because
I'm just saying go to the first
character and then get its address those
are one in the same now and then after
that is Ox
[Music]
40205.006.007 because that is just like
the diagram go to the I to the
exclamation point and to the null
character so all I'm doing now is using
my newfound understanding of what
Ampersand does and what the star does is
I'm just kind of playing around I'm
poking around in the computer's memory
just to demonstrate there's no magic
it's all there very deliberately because
I or printf or someone else put it there
yeah
thank you
really good observation so it's indeed
the case that high unlike 50 is kind of
ending up at a very low address not the
ox7 FF wherever it was that's actually
because long story short strings are
often stored in a different part of the
computer's memory more on that later
today for efficiency there's actually
only going to be one copy of the word hi
an exclamation point and the computer is
going to tuck it at sort of the
beginning of my memory but other various
like ins and floats and the like they
end up lower in memory by convention but
a good observation because that is
consistent here
all right so a couple final details then
on what's been going on here let me go
ahead and claim that
we implemented Char star or rather
string as a Char Star as follows as of
last week we were writing this code as
of this week we can now start writing
this code because Char star specifically
we invented in the cs50 library but it
turns out you've seen a way of inventing
your own data types recall this thing
here we played around last time with
data structures or the struct keyword in
C and briefly the type diff keyword
which defines a type for you and if I
highlight what's interesting here the
way we invented a person data type last
time was to define a person as having
two variables inside of it a structure
that encapsulates a name and
encapsulates a number now even though
the syntax is a little different today
because of the star thing notice that
this could be a similar application of
that idea if I want to create a type
called string highlighted in yellow here
then I use typedef to make it defined to
be Char star so this is literally all
that has ever been in cs50.h in addition
to those prototypes of functions we've
talked about type def Char star star
string is a one line code that brings
the word string as a data type into
existence and that's all that's ever
been there but the star the tar star is
just too much in week one we wait until
this point to sort of Peel back that
layer are any questions then on what a
string is what star or the ampersander
doing yeah
thank you
oh my God massive spoiler but yes if
that is that why when you compare two
strings as I briefly did uh or almost
did uh you problems arise and in fact
yes last week we used stir compare
s-t-r-cmp for a very deliberate reason
because yes the spoiler is I
accidentally would have compared two
addresses in memory not the strings at
those addresses
other questions here
no all right well before we give
ourselves maybe a 10 minute break here
we have lots of pieces of paper if
anyone wants to come on up and play with
this big stack of Post-its if you want
to make your own 8x8 grid of something
to share with the class if you're
artistically inclined come on up
otherwise let's take 10 minutes and
we'll return after 10. all right so
let's come back to this question of how
we can start to use these pointers and
these addresses ultimately in an
interesting way the goal ultimately next
week is going to be to use these
addresses to really stitch together more
complicated data structures than just
persons like last week or candidates in
the context of like an electoral
algorithm if you will and actually
really use our memory in the most
versatile way to represent not just
images but maybe videos and other
two-dimensional structures as well but
for now let's come back to this address
example Whittle it down to just a high
initially and see what's going on again
here underneath the hood so let me
re-add the cs50 library just so we use
our synonym for a moment that is the
word string and I'll redefine S as a
string and what I didn't mention before
is that these double quotes that you've
been using for some time are actually a
little special the double quotes are a
clue to the compiler that what is
between them is in fact a string as we
now know it which means the compiler
will do all the work of figuring out
where to put the H the I the exclamation
point and even adding for you
automatically a backslash zero and what
the compiler will do for you too is
figure out what address all four of
those chars ended up at and store it for
you in the variable s so that's why it
just kind of happens with strings
without using ampersands or even Stars
explicitly but the star at least has
been there because again string is just
synonymous now with Char star it's not
really as readable but it is now the
same idea so I'll leave string in place
just to do something sort of week one
style here for a moment and let's go
ahead and print out a few characters so
I'm going to use percent C this time and
I'm going to print out s bracket zero
and then I'm going to print out s
bracket one and S bracket 2.
literally doing sort of week three style
from last week a printing of every
character in s as though it were an
array so dot slash address should give
me h i exclamation point and if I really
want to get curious technically speaking
I could print out one more location and
let me go ahead and recompile make
address dot slash address and there is
it would seem the backslash zero I'm not
seeing Zero because I didn't type
literally the zero Char in ASCII it's
literally eight zero bits which are
technically unprintable if you will in
printf speak and so what I'm seeing here
is like a blank symbol that just means
there is something else there it's
apparently all eight zero bits but they
are there even though we're not seeing
them literally right now well let's go
ahead and peel back one of these layers
and let me go ahead and get rid of the
cs50 library
and get rid of therefore the word string
because again henceforth it's just Char
star nothing else is different I'm going
to now do make address dot slash address
and it's the same exact thing and now
let's just focus on the high rather than
even worry about that so I'm going to
recompile one last time and now I have h
i exclamation point well it turns out
that the array notation we used last
week was technically some of this
syntactic sugar sort of a neat way to
use syntax in a useful way but we can
see more explicitly today what the
square brackets for a string is actually
doing let me go ahead and do this let me
adventurously say I want to print out
not s bracket zero
but I want to print out whatever the
first character of s is so to be clear
what is s now it's the address of a
string okay but what is s really s is
the address of the first Char in a
string and again that's sufficient for
defining a string because eventually the
computer will see that there's a
backslash n at the end of it so s is
specifically the address of the first
character in a string
so that means using my new syntax if I
want to print out that first character I
can print out star s because recall that
star is the d-reference operator when
you don't repeat the word Char you don't
repeat the word in you just use the star
here that means go to that address
similarly if I in my sort of Newfound
knowledge of how strings work know that
the H comes first then the I right after
it then the exclamation point then the
backslash zero contiguously one byte
apart I could kind of start to do some
arithmetic I could go to S plus one byte
and print out the second character and I
could print out whatever is at s plus
two in fact doing what's generally known
as pointer arithmetic literally treating
pointers as the numbers they are
hexadecimal or decimal doesn't really
matter it's still just numbers and go
ahead and add one byte or two bytes to
them to start at the beginning of a
string and just kind of poke around from
left to right so this now is equivalent
to what we did last week using square
bracket notation but now I'm
re-implementing that same idea with the
sort of lower level Plumbing
understanding ampersands and stars now a
little bit more so if I remake this
program and do dot slash address I
should still see h i exclamation point
but what I'm really do is just kind of
demonstrating hopefully my my sort of
understanding of what really is going on
in the computer's memory now programmers
who are maybe trying to show off might
actually write this syntax I think the
more common syntax would be what we did
last week s bracket zero s bracket one
why it's just a little more readable and
like we don't need to sort of uh brag
about or care about this underlying
representation the square brackets last
week were an abstraction if you will on
top of what is lower level math but
that's all that's going on underneath
the hood we're poking around from bite
to bite to byte all right let me pause
here see if there's any questions on
that one
questions on this
let's do one more then just to
demonstrate that this is not even
specific to Strings let me go ahead and
get rid of all of this and let me give
myself an array of numbers like I did
last week so if I don't uh if I'm going
to declare all the numbers at once using
this funky curly brace notation I can do
like four six eight two seven five zero
so seven different numbers inside of an
array that's automatically initialized
like this I don't strictly speaking need
to say seven the compiler is smart
enough to figure out how many numbers I
put with commas between them and that
just gives me an array containing four
six eight two seven five zero so it
turns out I can print each of these
numbers in the familiar way I can do a
printf of percent I
backslash n and I can print numbers
bracket zero and let me just do some
quick copy paste just to print the first
three of these theoretically that should
print out four six eight and so forth
but I can do the same sort of
manipulation understanding what pointers
now are using pointer arithmetic so let
me actually unwind this and just go back
to one printf and instead of printing
numbers bracket zero like I might have
last week let me just go and print out
whatever is at that address so asterisk
numbers let me then print out the second
digit which is going to be whatever is
at numbers plus one and then let me do
this further and do whatever is at
numbers plus two and if I really want to
repeat this let me do it four more times
and do what's at location
three four five and six and that's seven
total numbers because I started counting
at zero so let me just quickly run this
make address dot slash address there are
those seven digits being printed but
there's something subtle but also kind
of useful here
each of these digits four six eight two
seven five zero is an INT why because I
made an array of integers but think back
how big is a typical integer have we
claimed
four bytes or 32 bits so it's worth
noting that I don't really need to worry
about that detail notice that I did not
do plus four plus eight plus twelve plus
16 plus 20 right I the programmer
strictly speaking don't need to worry
about how big the data type is this is
the power of pointer arithmetic the
compiler is smart enough to know that if
you add one to this pointer that is the
same as saying go one more piece of data
not just one byte so if it's an INT move
four if it's a second it move eight if
it's a third in move 12 pointer
arithmetic sort of handles that annoying
arithmetic for you so you can just think
of this as a number after a number after
a number that are back to back to back
but not one byte apart but four bytes
apart which is only to say plus one plus
two plus three Works no matter the data
type y because the compiler knows what
type of data you're talking about
now there's one other detail I should
reveal here
that I've kind of taken for granted in
the past I was using double quotes to
represent strings and I claim that the
compiler's smart enough to realize that
oh if I have double quote high that
means it's an array of h i exclamation
point and then the backslash zero notice
this usefulness it turns out that you
can actually treat arrays as though the
name of the array is itself a pointer
and this is actually going to be
something useful in upcoming problems
when we want to pass arrays around in
the computer's memory notice that
strictly speaking on line five there's
no pointers going on there's no star
there's no Ampersand there's nothing new
there and yet instantly on line seven
I'm sort of pretending that it is the
address and this is actually okay it
turns out that an array really can be
treated as the address of the first
element in that array the difference is
that there's no secret backslash zero
anywhere like this is just part of the
phone number here the ending in zero
that's not like a special backslash zero
so this is something we're going to take
advantage of too before law there's this
sort of interrelationship between
addresses and arrays that just generally
allows you to treat one as though it is
the other but the math is taken care of
for you or any questions then on on this
before we start to solve some of some
bigger problems yeah
potentially if you go beyond the end of
an array you might get a segmentation
fault the problem is that that symptom
is sometimes non-deterministic which
means that sometimes it will happen
sometimes it won't it often depends on
how far off the end of the array you
actually go you'll often not induce the
segmentation fall if you just kind of
poke a little too far but if you go way
too far it quite likely will but we'll
give you a tool today actually for
detecting and solving exactly that kind
of situation so let's go ahead now and
do something a little different in code
but that actually comes back to that
spoiler from earlier let me go ahead and
create a program called compare dot C
and in this program I'm going to go
ahead and allow myself the cs50 library
not so much for string but so that I can
actually use get in still which is way
easier than the way we'll see that c
normally lets you get input let me give
myself standard io.h do an INT main void
not worrying about command line
arguments today and let me go ahead and
get an INT I using get int and ask the
human for the value of I then let me
give myself an INT J ask the user for
another int calling it J
and then let me go ahead and kind of
naively but to your point earlier if I
equals equals J then let's go ahead and
print out something like same backslash
n
let's go ahead and print out different
if they are not in fact the same
so that would seem to be a program that
compares the value of two integers all
right so let's go ahead and run make
compare so far so good dot slash compare
okay I will be 50 I A J will be 50.
they're the same let's do it once more I
will be 50 J will be 42 they are
different so so far so good in this
first version of comparison
but as you might see where I'm going
with this let's move away from integers
and let's actually change these things
to char to Strings so I could do string
s over here get string s over here then
I could do uh string T over here and get
string over here asking the user for T
this time here and then I can compare
the two if s equals equals T and this is
a common convention if you've used s for
string already you can use T for the
next one at least for simple
demonstrations like this I'm going to
compare the two just like I did for ants
which worked great make compare
so far so good dot slash address oh
sorry wrong program dot slash compare
let me go ahead and type in something
like uh hi
exclamation point and buy exclamation
point which of course should definitely
be different let me run it again with
high exclamation point and high
exclamation point
huh different maybe I I messed up let's
maybe do lowercase is maybe that'll fix
but no those two are different so to
come back to what I described as a
spoiler earlier what's the fundamental
issue here to be clear
why is it saying different even though I
pretty sure I typed the same thing twice
yeah
yeah this is where it's now useful to
know that string has been an abstraction
a training wheel if you will and if we
take that away still use get string
because that's convenient still but if I
change string to be Char star it's a
little more explicit as to what s and
what T are s is a pointer to a Char that
is the address of a Char T is a pointer
to a Char that is the address of a Char
specifically the first character in s
and the first character in t
respectively so if I'm comparing these
two it should stand to reason that
they're going to be different why
because s might end up here in memory
and T might end up here in memory each
time I call getstring it is not smart
enough or Advanced enough to know that
wait a minute you type the same thing
I'm just going to hand you back the same
address that doesn't happen because we
did not design get string that way each
time I call it get string it returns
apparently a different copy of the
string that was typed in a high over
here and a high over here they might
look the same to the human but to the
computer they are different chunks of
memory and therefore it different
addresses and here too we can reveal
what is get string returning well up
until today it was returning a string so
to speak that's not really a thing
technically what get string has always
been doing is returning the address of
the first Char in a string and trusting
that we put a backslash zero at the end
of whatever the human typed in and
that's enough now for printf for
Sterling for you to know where a string
begins and ends so get string has
actually always returned a pointer it
has not returned a quote unquote string
per se but there are functions that can
solve this comparison for us recall that
I could do something like this I could
actually go in here and I could uh let's
see where was it so if I include stir
compare here and use it to pass in two
values s and t let's see now what
happens when I make compare
huh implicitly declaring Library
function stir compare with type int and
well there's a star so you might have
seen this error before and you might
have uh ignored most of it but there's
some evidence of stars or pointers going
on here it looks like I didn't include
the string.h header file so that's an
easy fix include string.h which despite
its name does not create a data type
called string it just has string related
functions in it like stir compare let's
make compare again
now it compiles dot slash compare now
let's type in high exclamation point and
even the same thing again these are now
oh I used it wrong okay user error
That was supposed to be impressive but
it's the opposite what did I do wrong
what did I do wrong here yeah
it returns three different values zero
if they're the same positive one becomes
before the other negative if the
opposite is true I just forgot that so
like I did last week correctly if I want
to compare them for equality per the
manual page I should be checking for
zero as the return value now may compare
dot slash compare enter let's try it one
last time high and high okay now they're
in fact the same and Justin thank you
all right
and indeed not that it's returning same
all the time if I type in high and then
buy it's indeed noticing that difference
as well well let me go ahead and do one
other thing here let's do one other
thing let me go ahead now and just
reveal more pictorially what's going on
let's get rid of the string comparison
and let's just print these things out
the simple way to print this out would
be with percent s and again percent s is
special printf knows taking an address
and start there print every character up
until the backslash ends so let's just
hand it s and do that and then let's do
one more percent s comma T this is again
sort of a mix of weeks one and this week
because I got rid of the word string I'm
using Char star but I'm still using
printf and percent s in the same way let
me go ahead and run compare now and if I
type high and high I should see the same
thing twice so they look the same but
here now we have the syntax today to
print out the actual addresses of these
things so let me just change the S to a
p e because p means don't go to the
address and print it it means just print
the address as a pointer so make compare
dot slash compare and now let's type in
hi and once more and I should see indeed
two slightly different addresses given
in hexadecimal one's got a B at the end
one's got an F at the end and they are
indeed a few bytes apart so this is just
confirming what our suspicions have
actually been so what does this mean
perhaps in the computer's memory well
let's kind of take a look I've zoomed
out so I have a little more squares to
look at it once here might be s in
memory when I do string s equals or Char
star s equals I get a variable that's up
size one two three four five six seven
eight because I claimed earlier that on
Modern systems pointers are generally
eight bytes nowadays so they can count
even higher and inside of the computer's
memory also might be high and I don't
know where it ends up so for the sake of
discussion it ended up down here that's
what was free when I ran the program Hi
exclamation point backslash zero maybe
it ended up for the sake of discussion
at ox123 4 5 and 6. so to be clear what
is s storing
once the assignment operator copies from
right to left what is s storing if I
Advance one more
slide yeah
0x123 the presumption being that if a
string is defined by the address of its
first Char and that address of its first
R is ox123 then that's indeed what
should be in the variable s and so
technically that's what's been happening
with that assignment operator from right
to left get string indeed returns a
string so to speak but more properly it
Returns the address of a Char what's
been then copied from right to left
using that assignment operator all these
weeks is indeed that address now
technically we don't really need to care
about where these addresses are it
suffices to just think about them sort
of referentially but let's first
consider where T might be T is just
another variable that I created on my
second line of code maybe it ends up
there maybe somewhere else for the sake
of discussion I'll draw it left and
right where did the second word end up
that I typed in well suppose the second
copy of high ended up at Ox four five
six four five seven four five eight four
five nine what ended up in t I'll plug
this one off myself ox4 five six
presumably and so this is now a
pictorial representation of Y and let's
abstract away everything else when I
compared s against T using equal equals
but based on the picture they're
obviously not the same one is over here
one is over here and per a moment ago
one is ox123 the other is ox456 yes
technically they're pointing at
something that's the same but that just
reveals how stir compare works stir
compare is apparently a function that
takes in the address of a string as its
argument and the address of another
string as its argument it goes to the
first character in each of those strings
respectively and probably has like a for
Loop or a while loop and just goes from
left to right comparing looking for the
same chars left and right and if it
doesn't notice any differences boom it
returns zero if it does notice a
difference it returns a positive or A
negative value and that's very similar
recall to how we implemented string
length ourselves last week I sort of
used a for loop I was looking for a
backslash zero stir compare is probably
a little similar in spirit looping from
left to right but comparing this time
not just counting are any questions then
on string comparison and why it is that
when you stir compare and not equals
equals yeah
do pointers have addresses yes so we
won't do that today but I could actually
use the Ampersand operator on S or on T
that would give me the equivalent of a
Char star star that itself could be
stored elsewhere in memory that's where
it ends we don't sort of do that
recursively forever there's star and
there's star star but yes that is a
thing and it's very often useful in the
context of like two-dimensional arrays
which we haven't really talked about but
that is a feature of the language too
but not today
good question
all right so what might we now do to
take things up a notch well let's go
ahead and Implement a different program
here that maybe try is copying some
values just to demonstrate this let me
open up a file called how about copy.c
and I'm going to start off with a few
includes so let's include the cs50
library just so we have a way of getting
user input let's include how about
standard i o as always let's
preemptively include string.h and maybe
one other in a moment let's do int main
void as before and then in here let's
get a string from the user and just call
it s for Simplicity and heck we can
actually just call this uh Char star
star if we want or string since we're
using the cs50 library but we'll come
back to that let's now make a copy of s
and do s equals T using a single
assignment operator and then let's check
something like this let's go into the
first character of T which is T bracket
zero and then let's upper case it using
that function that we've used in the
past of two upper T bracket zero
semicolon and actually I should go back
up here if I'm using two upper or if
you've used two lower or is upper or is
lower I might not remember this offhand
but it was in another header file called
C type dot h there was a bunch of
helpful functions in that Library as
well now at the very last line of the
program let's just print out what both s
and TR
by simply printing out percent s for
each of them and T is percent s also not
percent T of course and let's see what
happens here so let me make copy oh my
God so many mistakes what did I do wrong
oh
okay that was unintended string T equals
s sorry so I'm creating two variables s
and t respectively and I'm copying s
into T make copy enter there we go dot
slash copy
and let's now type in for instance uh
how about high exclamation point and
I'll lower case this time and now what
gets printed aha
I don't think that's what I intended
so to speak here because notice that I
got s from the user so that checks out I
then copied T into s which looks correct
that's what we always use assignment for
then I uppercase the first letter in t
but not s at least in my code then I
printed s and t and then notice
apparently both s and t got capitalized
so if you're sort of getting starting to
get a little comfortable with what's
going on underneath the hood like what
what's the fundamental problem here why
did both get capitalized
why did both get capitalized yeah over
here
yeah they're representing the same
address so C is really literal if you
create another variable called T and you
assign it the value of s you are
literally assigning it the value in s
which is like ox123 or something like
that and so at that point in the story
both s and t presumably have a value of
ox123 which means they technically point
to the same h i exclamation point in
memory nowhere did I tell the computer
to give me a copy of Hi exclamation
point per se I literally said just copy
s so here's where an understanding of
what s literally is kind of explains the
situation I'm only copying the pointers
so what actually went on in memory let's
take a look here at this grid if I
created s initially maybe it ends up
here and I created high in lower case
and it ended up down here then the
address was again like ox123 four five
six ox123 is what's in s if then I
create a second variable called T and I
call it a string AKA HR Star maybe it
again ends up here but when I copy s
into T by doing T equals s semicolon
that literally just copies s into T
which puts the value ox123 there so if
we now abstract away all these numbers
and just think about a picture with
arrows what we've drawn in the
computer's memory is this two different
pointers but storing the same address
which means the breadcrumbs lead to the
same place and so if you follow the tea
breadcrumb and capitalize the first
letter it is functionally the same as
copying the changing the first letter in
the version S as well
so what's the solution then to this kind
of problem
like even if you have no idea how to do
it in code like what's the gist of what
I really intended which is I want a
genuine copy of s called T I want a new
h i exclamation point backslash zero
what do I need to do to make that happen
thoughts
so there is a function called stir copy
strcpy which is a a possible answer to
this question the catch with stir copy
is that you have to tell in advance not
only what the source string is the one
you want to copy you also need to pass
in the address of a chunk of memory into
which you can copy the string and here's
one thing we haven't seen yet and we
need one more building block today if
you will we haven't yet seen a way to
create new chunks of memory and then let
some other function copy into them and
for this we're going to introduce
something called dynamic memory
allocation and this is the last and most
powerful feature perhaps today whereby
we're going to introduce two functions
malloc and free where malloc means
memory allocate which literally does
just that it's a function that takes a
number is input how many bytes of memory
do you want the operating system to find
for you somewhere in that Big Grid it's
going to find it and it's going to
return to the address of the first byte
of contiguous memory back to back to
back and then you can do anything you
want with that chunk of memory free is
going to do the opposite when you're
done using a chunk of memory that Malik
has given you you can say free it and
that means you hand it back to the
operating system and then the operating
system can use it for something else
later so this is actually evidence of a
common problem in programming if your
Mac your PC has ever been in the habit
of starting to get like really really
slow or it's kind of slowing to a crawl
heck maybe it even freezes one of the
possible exclamation explanations could
be that the program you're running by
apple or Microsoft to whoever maybe
they're using malloc or some equivalent
asking the operating system Mac OS or
Windows for give me more memory I need
more memory the user is creating more
images the user is typing a longer essay
give me more memory more memory if the
program has a bug and never actually
frees any of that memory your computer
might end up using all of the available
memory and honestly humans are not very
good at handling Corner cases like that
very often programs computers just
freeze at that point or get really
really slow because they start trying to
be creative when there's not enough
memory left so one of the reasons for a
computer really slowing down might be
calling for malloc a lot or some
equivalent but never freeing it which is
to say you should always use these two
functions in concert and free memory
once you are done with it so let me go
ahead and do this in code and solve this
problem properly let me go ahead and do
this
before I copy s into T using something
like stir copy I first need to get a
bunch of memory from the computer so to
do that let's make this super clear that
we're doing with pointer so I'm going to
change my strings to char stars for both
s and t and what I technically am going
to store in T is the CH is the address
of a available chunk of memory to do
that I can ask the computer to allocate
memory for me and how many bytes if I
want to create a copy of h i exclamation
point I need how many bytes
good four because I need the H the I the
exclamation point and additional space
for the backslash zero it's up to me to
understand that and ask for it it's not
going to happen magically nothing does
in C so I could just naively type 4
there and that would be correct if I
type in h i exclamation point or any
other three letter word or phrase but to
do this dynamically I should probably do
something like Sterling of s plus one
for the additional null character recall
that string length does it in the sort
of the English sense it Returns the
length of the string you see plus one
also takes into account the fact that
I'm going to need that backslash n now
let me do this old school style first
let me go ahead and manually copy the
string t uh s into T first so four uh
int i x equals zero I is less than the
string length of s i plus plus then
inside my for Loop I'm going to do T
bracket I equals s bracket I but
actually I want the
null character two so I want to do the
length of the string plus one more and
heck I think I learned an optimization
last time if I'm doing this again and
again I could really do n equals
Sterling of s plus 1 and then do I is
less than n just as a nice design
optimization I think this for Loop will
actually handle the process then of
copying every character from s into
every available byte of memory in t or I
could get rid of all of that and take
your suggestion which is to use Stir
copy which takes as its first argument
the destination and its second argument
the source so copy from right to left in
this case two that's going to do all of
that automatically for me as well now I
think I'm good I can now capitalize
safely the first character in t which is
now a different chunk of memory than S
and then I can print them both out to
see that one has not changed but the
other has so make copy
all right what did I do wrong implicitly
declaring Library function malloc dot
dot so we've seen this kind of error
before
what is even if you don't know quite how
to solve it what's the essence of the
solution what do I need to do to fix
this kind of problem involving
implicitly declaring a library function
what did I forget yeah
I need to include the library and I
could look this up in the manual uh or I
can know it off the top of my head I
just forgot it there's another Library
we'll occasionally need now called
standard lib standard library that
contains malloc and free prototypes and
some other stuff too all right let me
just clear this away and do make copy
one more time now I'm good dot slash
copy enter all right s I'm going to type
in high lowercase T and S now come back
as intended s is untouched it would seem
but T is now capitalized
all right any questions then on what we
just did in code yeah
indeed there's a few improvements I want
to make so let me actually do those
right now technically I should practice
what I preached and I should indeed when
I'm done with T free T fortunately I
don't have to worry about how Big T was
the opera the computer remembers how
many bytes it gave me and it will go
free all of them not just the first I
should do free T I don't need to do free
s and I shouldn't because that is
handled automatically by the cs50
library s recall came from get string
and we actually have some fancy code in
place that makes sure that at the end of
your program's execution we free any
memory that we allocated so we don't
actually waste memory like I described
earlier but there's actually a couple of
other things if I really want to be
pedantic I should put in here it turns
out that sometimes malloc can fail and
sometimes malloc doesn't have enough
memory available because maybe your
computer is doing so much stuff there's
just no more RAM available so
technically I should do something like
this if T equals equals null with two
L's today okay then I should just return
one or something to say that there was a
problem I should probably print an error
message too but for now I'm going to
keep it simple I should also probably
check this this is a little risky of me
if I'm doing T bracket zero this is
assuming that there is a letter there
but what if the human the human just hit
enter at the prompt and didn't even type
h let alone h i exclamation point what
if there is no T bracket zero so
technically what I should probably do
here is if the length of T is at least
greater than zero then go ahead and
safely capitalize the first letter of it
and then at the very end if all goes
well I can return 0 thereby signifying
that indeed this thing was successful so
yes these two functions malloc and free
should be in concert and so if you call
malloc you should call free eventually
but you did not call malloc for S so you
should not call free for s
all right yeah other question
why did I do malloc plus one so malloc
sorry malloc of string length of s plus
one the string length is sort of the
literal length of the string as a human
would perceive it in English so h i
exclamation point Sterling gives me
three but I know now as of last week in
this week what a string technically is
and a string always has an extra byte
the onus is on me to understand and
apply that lesson learned so that I
actually give stir copy enough room for
that trailing null character and here's
just an annoying thing when we call the
backslash zero and UL uh last week uh it
turns out that n-u-l-l is the same idea
it's also zero but it's zero in the
context of pointer so long story short
you never really write nul I've just
said it and we saw it on the screen you
will start writing n-u-l-l when you want
to check whether or not a pointer is
valid or not and what I mean by that is
this if malloc fails and there's just
not enough memory left inside of the
computer for you it's got to return a
special value and that's special value
is n-u-l-l in all capital letters that
signifies something went wrong do not
trust that I'm giving you a useful
return value
other questions
on these copies thus far yeah over there
good question will stir copy not work
without Malik do you kind of need both
in this case because stir copy by
definition if I pull up its manual page
needs a destination to put the copied
characters it's not sufficient just to
say Char star T semicolon that only
gives you a pointer but I need another
chunk of memory that's just as big as Hi
exclamation point backslash zero so
malloc gives me a whole bunch of memory
and then stir copy fills it with Hi
exclamation point backslash zero so
again that's why we're sort of going
down to this lower level because once
you understand what needs to be done you
now have the functions to do it so let's
actually consider what we just solved so
in this next version of the program
where I actually introduced malloc T was
initialized to the return value of
malloc and maybe the memory that I got
back was here
ox456-457-458-459 I've left it blank
initially because nothing is put there
automatically by malloc I just get a
chunk of memory that is now mine to use
as I see fit I then then assign T to
that return value which points T at the
first address notice there's no
backslash zero this is not yet a string
it's just a chunk of memory four bytes
an array of four bytes what stir copy
eventually did for me was it copied the
H over the I over the exclamation point
over and the backslash zero and if I
didn't want to use Stir copy or I forgot
that it existed my for Loop would have
done exactly the same thing
all right any questions then
on these examples here
any questions yeah
good question after Matlock if I had
then still done just T equals s it
actually would have recreated the same
original Problem by just copying ox123
from s into T so then I would have been
left with a picture that looked like
this a few steps ago I would have and I
can't quite do it live this Arrow if I
did what you just described would now be
pointing over here and so I wouldn't
have fundamentally solved the problem I
would have just additionally wasted four
bytes temporarily that I'm not actually
using yeah
um you can you do you always use Malik
and stir copy together not necessarily
these are both solving two different
problems malloc's giving me enough
memory to make a copy stir copies doing
the copy however you could actually use
an array if you wanted of characters and
you could use Stir copy on that and
there's other use cases for stir copy
but thus far it's a reasonable mental
model to have that if you want to copy
strings you use malloc and then stir
copy or your own homegrown Loop yeah
foreign
say that once more
no it well good question uh if I uh I
didn't well stir copy per its
documentation we'll copy the whole
string plus the null character at the
end it just assumes there will be one
there it's therefore up to you to pass
stir copy a long enough chunk of memory
to have room for that if I only ask
malloc for three bytes that could have
potentially created a memory problem
whereby stir copy would just still
blindly copy one two three four bytes
but technically it should only have only
touched three of those you do not yet
have access to the fourth one or the
rights to it because you never asked
malloc for it uh yeah
correct the number inside Mallock it's
one argument is the number of bytes you
want back
yes the onus is on you the programmer to
remember or frankly use a function to
figure out how many bytes you actually
need that's why I did not ultimately
type in four manually I use Stir length
plus one so the plus one is necessary if
you understand how strings are
represented but using Sterling means
that I can actually play around with any
types of inputs and it will dynamically
figure out the length
so suffice it to say there's so many
ways already where you can start to
break programs let's give you at least
one tool for finding mistakes that you
might make and indeed in upcoming
problem sets will you use this to find
bugs in your own code not just using
printf not just using the built-in
debugger but another tool here as well
so let me go ahead and deliberately
write a program called memory.c that has
some memory related errors let me
include standard io.h at the top and let
me include standard lib.h at the top so
I have access to malloc now let me do
int main void and then inside of main
let me do this I want to allocate maybe
how about three space for three integers
why just for the sake of discussion so
I'm going to go ahead and do malloc of
three but I don't want three bytes I
want three integers and an integer is
four bytes so technically I could do
this three times four or I could do 12.
but again that's making certain
assumptions and if I run this program on
a slightly different computer ants might
be a different size so the better way to
do this would be three times whatever
the size is of an INT and this is just
an operator you can use anytime if you
just want to find out on this computer
how big is an INT how big is a float or
something else so that's going to give
me that many that much memory for three
ends what do I want to assign this to
well malloc returns an address
pointers are addresses so I'm going to
create a pointer to an INT called X and
assign it the value
so what am I doing here this is a little
less obvious but again go back to basics
the right hand side here gives me a
chunk of memory for three integers
malloc Returns the address of the first
byte of that chunk how do I store the
address of anything I need a pointer the
Syntax for today is
type of data star the type of data in
question is a three ins so I do in Star
X
again it's kind of purposeless only for
sort of instructional purposes here but
this is equivalent now to having a chunk
of memory of size 12 in total presumably
so I can technically now do this I can
go into maybe the first location and
assign it the number 72 like the other
day second location number uh number 73
and the Third location may be the uh
locate the number 33. now I've
deliberately made two mistakes here
because I'm trying to trip over my
newfound understanding or my sort of
greenness with understanding pointers
one I didn't remember that I should be
treating chunks of memory as zero
indexed malloc essentially returns an
array if you want to think of it as that
an array of three ants or more
technically the address of a chunk of
memory that could fit three ends so I
can use my square bracket notation or I
could be really cool and use pointer or
arithmetic but this is a little more
user friendly but I have made two
mistakes
I did not start indexing at zero so line
seven should have been X bracket zero
line eight should have been X bracket
one and then line nine should have been
X bracket two so first mistake the
second mistake that I've made as a side
effect is I'm also touching memory that
I shouldn't
X bracket three would mean go to the
fourth INT in the chunk of memory that
came back I only asked for enough memory
for three ants not four so this is
what's called a buffer overflow I am
accidentally but deliberately at the
moment going Beyond boundaries of this
array this chunk of memory so bad things
happen but not necessarily by just
running your program let me go ahead and
just try this make memory
and you'll see here that it compiles
okay dot slash memory and it actually
does not segmentation fault which comes
back to that point of non-determinism
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
it depends on how bad of a mistake you
made but there's a program that can spot
these kinds of mistakes and I'm going to
go ahead and expand my terminal window
for a moment and I'm going to run not
just dot slash memory but a program
called valgrind dot slash memory this is
a command that comes with a lot of
computer systems that's designed to find
memory related bugs in code so it's a
new tool in your toolkit today and
you'll use it with the coming problem
sets I'm going to run this now its
output honestly is hideous but there's a
few things that will start to jump out
and will help you with tools and the
problem set to see these kinds of things
here's the first mistake invalid right
of size four that's on memory.c line 9
per my highlights so let me go look at
line nine in what sense is this an
invalid right of size four well I'm
touching memory that I shouldn't it and
I'm touching it as though it's an INT
and an INT is four bytes size four so
again this takes some practice to get
used to the nomenclature here but this
is now a clue for me the programmer that
not only did I screw up but I screwed up
related to memory and so this is just
kind of a hint if you will it's not
going to necessarily tell you exactly
how to fix it you have to kind of
wrestle with the the semantics but
invalid right of size four oh okay so I
should not have indexed past the
boundary here all right so I shouldn't
have done that so let me go ahead then
and change this to uh zero one and two
perhaps here all right so let me go
ahead and recompile my code make memory
dot slash memory still doesn't seem to
be broken but it is technically buggy
let me go ahead and run valgrind again
so valgrind
of dot slash memory enter
and now there's fewer scary less scary
output now but there's still something
in there notice this 12 bytes in one
blocks no regard for grammar there are
definitely lost in Lost record one of
one super cryptic but this is hinting at
a so-called memory leak the blocks of
memory are lost in the sense that I
mallocked them I asked for them but I
never take a guess
freed them I have a memory leak and this
is the Arcane way of saying you've
screwed up you have a memory leak so
this is an easy fix fortunately once I'm
done with this memory I just need to
free it at the end so now let me go
ahead and rerun make memory it still
runs fine so all the while I might have
thought incorrectly my code is correct
but let me run valgrin one more time
valgrin of dot slash memory enter now
this is pretty good all heat blocks were
freed whatever that means no leaks are
possible and even though it's still a
little cryptic there's no other error
here and in fact it's pretty explicit
error summary zero errors from zero
contexts dot dot dot so even though this
is one of the most Arcane tools we'll
use it's also one of the most powerful
because it can see things that you the
human might not and maybe even that the
debugger might not it does a much closer
reading of your code while it's running
to figure out exactly what is going on
all right any questions then on this
tool and we'll guide you after today
with actually using this too
just helps you find memory related
mistakes that you might now be capable
of making
all right let's do one other memory
related thing let me shrink my terminal
window here let me create one other file
here called garbage.c so it turns out
there's a term of art called garbage
values in programming that we can reveal
as follows let me include standard io.h
and let me include how about standard
lib.h and then let me give myself
Ant-Man void and then in this relatively
short program let me give myself like
three ins using last week's notation
just int scores bracket three for like
three quiz scores or whatever then let
me go ahead and do four into I equals
zero I less than three I plus plus then
let me go ahead and print out percent I
backslash n scores bracket I semicolon
that's it
this code producer is
going to compile and it's going to run
but what is my logical bug I've sort of
Forgotten a step even though the code
that's written is not so wrong yeah
yeah I didn't provide the score so I
didn't actually initialize the array
called scores to have any scores
whatsoever what's curious about this
though is that the computer technically
doesn't mind let me go ahead and sort of
playfully make garbage enter and it's
kind of an app description because what
I'm about to see are so-called garbage
values when you the programmer do not
initialize your code variables to have
values sometimes who knows what's going
to be there the computer's been doing
some other things there's a bit of work
that happens even before your code runs
in the computer so there might be
remnants of past ins Char strings floats
anything else in there and what you're
seeing is those garbage values which is
to say you should never forget as I just
did to initialize the value of some
variable and this is actually pretty
dangerous and there have been many
examples of software being compromised
because of one of these issues where a
variable wasn't initialized and all of a
sudden users maybe people on the
internet in the context of web
applications could suddenly see the
contents of someone else's memory or
remnants maybe someone's password that
had been previously typed in or some
other value like a credit card number
that had been previously typed in there
are different defense mechanisms in
place to generally make this not so
likely but it's certainly very possible
at least in this kind of context to see
values that you probably shouldn't
because they might be remnants from
something else that use them so this is
to say again you sort of have this great
power now to manipulate memory but also
now you have this great sort of hacking
ability to poke around the concepts of
memory and this is exactly what hackers
sometimes do when trying to find
ways to exploit systems
for any questions here
no all right let's go ahead and take a
quick five minute break and when we come
back we'll build on these final topics
see you in five we are back uh first
just a little programmer of humor from
XKCD which hopefully now will make a
little bit of sense to you and what
let's we'll also do next is take a look
at a short two minute video that uh
animates uh with claymation if you will
from our friends at Stanford exactly
what happens now if you have an
understanding of what garbage values are
and how they get there and what happens
then if you misuse them it's one thing
just to print them out as I just did
it's another if you actually mistake a
garbage value for a valid pointer
because garbage values are just zeros
and ones somewhere numbers that is but
if you use that new dereference operator
the star and try to go to a garbage
value thinking incorrectly that it's a
valid pointer bad things can happen
computers can crash or more familiarly
uh segmentation faults can happen so
allow me to introduce if we could dim
the lights for two minutes uh our friend
Binky from Stanford
hey Binky wake up it's time for pointer
fun
what's that learn about pointers oh
goody
goody well to get started I guess we're
gonna need a couple pointers
this code allocates two pointers which
can
pull I see the two pointers but they
don't seem to be pointing to anything
that's right and
pointers don't point to anything the
things they point to are called pointees
and setting them up is a separate step
oh right right I knew that the pointees
are separate sure so how do you allocate
a pointy
okay well this code allocates a new
integer Point T and this part sets X to
point to it
hey that looks better so make it do
something
okay I'll dereference the pointer X to
store the number 42 into its Point e for
this trick I'll need my magic wand of
dereferencing your magic wand of
dereferencing uh
this is what the code looks like I'll
just set up the number and
hey look there it goes so doing a
dereference on X follows the arrow to
access its Point e in this case the
store 42 in there hey try using it to
store the number 13 through the other
pointer why
okay I'll just go over here to Y and get
the number 13 set up and then take the
wand of dereferencing and just oh
oh hey that didn't work
say uh Binky I don't think dereferencing
Y is a good idea because uh you know
setting up the point D is a separate
step and uh I don't think we ever did it
Point yeah we allocated the pointer y
but we never set it to point to a point
d
very observant hey you're looking good
there Binky can you fix it so that y
points to the same pointy as X sure or I
use my magic wand of pointer assignment
is that going to be a problem like
before no this doesn't touch the
pointe's it just changes one pointer to
point to the same thing as another
oh I see now y points to the same place
as X
so so wait now Y is fixed it has a
pointy so you can try the wand of
dereferencing again to send the 13 over
uh okay
okay here goes
hey look at
now dereferencing works on why and
because the pointers are sharing that
one point e they both see the 13. yeah
sharing uh whatever so are we gonna
switch places now oh look we're out of
time but
it's from our friend Nick parlante at
Stanford so let's consider what Nick did
here as Binky so here's kind of all the
code together these first couple of
lines were not bad and uh notice that in
Stanford's code they moved the Stars to
the left that's fine again more
conventional might be this syntax here
these two lines are fine it's okay to
create variables even pointers and not
assign them a value initially so long as
you eventually do so we eventually do
here with this line we assign 2x the
return value of Matlock which is
presumably the address of something to
be fair we should really be checking for
null as well but that's not the biggest
problem here the biggest problem is not
even this next line which means go to
the memory location in X and store the
number 42 there that's fine because
again malloc Returns the address of some
chunk of memory this chunk of memory is
big enough for an INT X is therefore
going to store the address of that chunk
that's big enough for an INT star X
recalls the dereference operator means
go to that address and put 42 in it's
like going to the mailbox and putting
the number 42 in it instead of taking
the number 50 out like we did before but
why is this line bad this is where Binky
sort of lost his head so to speak
why is this bad yeah
exactly we haven't yet allocated space
for why there's no mention of malloc
there's no assignment of why even to
that same memory so this would be go to
the address and why but if there is no
known address and why it is a so-called
garbage value which means go to some
random address that you have no control
over and boom that might cause what
we've seen in the past perhaps as a
segmentation fault now this fortunately
is the kind of thing that if you don't
quite have the eye for it yet valgrind
that new tool could help you find as
well but it's just another example of
again the sort of upside and downside of
having control now over memory at this
level all right well let's go ahead and
do one other thing considering from last
week that this notion of swapping was
actually really common operation we had
all of our volunteers come up we had to
swap a lot of things during bubble sorts
and even selection sort and we just kind
of took for granted that you know the
two humans would swap themselves just
fine but there needs to be code to do
that if you actually Implement bubble
sort selection sort or anything that
involves swapping so let's consider some
code like this we'll keep it simple like
last week and where we wanted to swap
some values like int a and int B for
instance here void because I'm not going
to return a value but I have a function
called swap so here for instance might
be some code for this uh but why is it
so complicated here let's actually take
a step back why don't we do this here I
think we have time for one more
volunteer could we get someone to come
on up you have to be comfy on camera and
oh and you're being asked to help with
your oh I'll go with the friend pointing
so whoever has their friend doing this
here
no now they're pointing over here now
literally an arm is being Twisted okay
come on down that backfired
come on over
and what is your name
Marina nice to meet you who were you
trying to volunteer
that's okay
so here we have for Marina two glasses
of liquid orange and purple just so that
they're super obvious and suppose that
the problem of at hand like last week
it's just to swap two values like as
though these two glasses represented two
people and we want to swap them but
let's consider these glasses to be like
variables or location in an array and
you know what I'd really like you to
swap the values so like orange has to go
in there and purple has to go in there
how would you do it and we'll see if we
can then translate that to code
okay what did you say a little letter
all right yeah so presumably you're sort
of struggling mentally with how you
would do this without having an extra
cup so good foresight here let me go
ahead and we do have a temporary
variable if you will so if I hand you
this how would you now solve this
problem
no that's oh well okay do it go with
your instincts
okay sure go ahead go to whatever your
instincts are
yeah so a little so strictly speaking
probably shouldn't have moved the
glasses just because that would be like
moving the array locations so let's
actually do it one more time but the
glasses now have to go back where they
originally are so how would you swap
these now using this temporary variable
okay good
otherwise we'd be completely uprooting
the array for instance by just
physically moving it around
so you move the orange into this
temporary variable then you copied the
purple into where the orange was and now
presumably excellent the Orange is going
to end up where the purple once was and
this temporary variable it's sort of
some extra memory it was necessary at
the time but not necessary ultimately
but a round of applause if we could and
thank you for doing that so well
so
right the fact that it sort of instantly
occurred to Mariana that like you need
some temporary variable is a perfect
translation to code and in fact this
code here that we might Glimpse now is
reminiscent of exactly that algorithm
where A and B at the end of the day are
the same chunks of memory just like the
second time the two glasses have to kind
of stay put even though we're physically
lifting them but they're going back to
where they were it's kind of like having
two values A and B and you just have a
temporary variable into which you copy a
then you change a with B then you go and
change B with whatever the original
value of a was because you temporarily
stored it in this temporary variable TMP
unfortunately this code doesn't
necessarily work as intended so let me
go over to my vs code here and open up a
program called swap.c and in swap.c Let
Me Whip up something really quickly here
with how about include standard io.h int
main void inside of main let me do
something like in X gets one and Y gets
two let me just print out as a visual
confirmation that X is percent i y is
percent I backslash n plugging in X and
Y respectively then let me call a swap
function that will invent in just a
moment swap X and Y and then let me
print out again X is percent i y is
percent I backslash and just to print
out again what they are because
presumably I should see one two first
then 2 1 the second time now how is swap
going to be implemented let me implement
it exactly as on the screen a moment ago
so void swap int X or let's call it int
a for consistency in B but I could
always call those anything I want in
temp gets a A gets b b gets temp so
exactly as I proposed a moment ago and
exactly as Mariana really implemented it
using these glasses of water I need to
now include my prototype as always so
nothing new there and I'll just copy
paste that up here and now let's go
ahead and run this so make swap
so far so good swap X is now one y is
two x is one y is two
so there seems to be a bit of a bug here
but why might this be this code does not
in fact work even though it obviously
works in reality yeah
good and let me summarize A and B do
indeed have different addresses of X and
Y and in fact what happens when you call
a function like this on line 11 calling
swap passing in X and Y you are calling
a function by value so to speak and this
is a term of art that just means you are
passing in copies of X and Y
respectively and calling them A and B in
the context of this function but they're
indeed copies now technically these
names are local only I could have called
this x I could have called this y I
could have changed this to X this to Y
this to X and this to Y the problem
would still remain just because you use
the same names in One function as you do
elsewhere that doesn't mean they're the
same they just look the same to you but
indeed swap is going to get copies of
this X and Y and in this context this
scope so to speak X and Y will be copies
of the original so for clarity let me
revert this back to A and B just to make
super clear that they're indeed
different albeit copies but there's
indeed a problem there this function
actually works fine in fact notice this
let me go ahead and print out inside of
this printf a is percent i b is percent
I backslash n and then I'll print A and
B and let me do that same thing at the
beginning of this function before it
does any work let me go ahead and rerun
make swap
dot slash Swap and this is promising
initially X is one y is two a is one B
is 2 a is two B is one but then nope X
is one y is two so if anything I've
confirmed that the logic is Right
Mariana's logic is right but there's
something about C there's something
about using one function versus another
that's actually creating a problem here
the fact that I'm passing in copies of
these values is creating this problem so
what in fact is going on well again
inside of your computer's memory there's
these little chips and we've been
talking about them abstractly it's just
this grid of memory locations it turns
out that your computer uses this memory
in a pretty conventional way it's not
just kind of random where it just puts
stuff wherever is available it actually
uses like different parts of the memory
for different purposes and you have
control over a lot of it but the
computer uses some of it for itself and
let's go ahead and zoom out from this
and consider that within your computer's
memory what a computer will typically do
is actually store initially all of the
the zeros and ones that you compiled in
the top of your computer's memory so to
speak so when you compile a program and
then you run it with DOT slash whatever
or on a Mac or PC you double click on it
the computer first the operating first
operating system first loads all of your
program zeros and ones AKA machine code
into just one big chunk of memory at the
top so to speak
below that it stores Global variables
any variables you have created in your
program that are outside of Main and
outside of any functions generally like
the top of your file globals tend to go
at the top there then there's this chunk
of memory that's generally known as the
Heap and we saw that word briefly in
valgren's output and then there's this
other chunk of memory called the stack
and it turns out that up until this week
you were using the stack heavily anytime
you use local variables in a function
they end up on the stack anytime you use
malloc that memory ends up on the Heap
now as the arrow suggests this actually
looks like a problem waiting to happen
because if you use more and more and
more Heap and more and more and more
stack it's like you know two things
barreling down the tracks of one another
this does not end well and that's
actually a problem if you've ever heard
the phrase stack Overflow or use the
website this is the origin of its name
when you start to use more and more and
more memory by calling lots and lots of
functions or using lots and lots of
local variables you use a lot of this
stack memory or if you use malloc a lot
and keep calling malloc Mallock Mallock
and never really or rarely calling free
you just use more and more memory and
eventually these two things might
overflow each other at which point
you're just kind of out of luck the
program will crash or something bad will
happen so the onus is kind of on you
just to don't do that but this is the
design generally of what's going on in
inside of your computer's memory now
within that memory though there are
certain conventions focusing on here the
stack and in fact let me go over here
with a marker and say that this
represents like the bottom of my memory
ultimately and so here we have a whole
bunch of wooden blocks and each of these
squares represents a byte of memory and
this for instance might represent four
bytes altogether good enough for an INT
or something like that so in my original
code that I wrote earlier that is in
fact buggy
what is in fact going on inside the swap
function we can kind of visualize it
like this when you run dot slash swap or
any program for that matter main is the
first function to get called with a c
program and so I'm just going to label
this bottom row of memory as Main and
what were the two variables I had in
Maine called in this code
yeah
X and Y and each of those words and N so
that's four bytes so it's kind of
deliberate that I reserved a four uh a
chunk of wood here that's four bytes so
let me just call this X and I'm just
going to write the number one in this
box here and then I had my other
variable Y and I'm going to put the
number 2 there what happens when main
calls swap like it does in this code
here well it has two variables of its
own A and B
and a initially is 1 and B is initially
two but it has a third variable temp
which is the local variable in addition
to the arguments A and B that are passed
in so I'm going to call this temp TMP
over here and what is the value of temp
well we have to look back at the code
temp initially gets the value of a all
right the value of a was one so temp
initially gets one that's step one in my
three line program okay a equals B so
that is a sign from the right to the
left of the B into the a so B is 2 a is
this so let me go ahead and erase this
and just overwrite that so at this
moment in the story you have two copies
of two
so that's that's okay though because the
third line of code says temp gets copied
into B so what's temp one gets copied
into B so let me overwrite this two with
a one
and now what happens now unfortunately
the code ends swap doesn't actually do
anything with the result and the problem
in C is that I could have had a return
value I could go in there and change
void to int but which one am I going to
return the a or the B the whole goal is
to swap two values and it seems kind of
lame if you can't write a function to do
something as common per last week's
sorting algorithms as swapping two
values but what really happens well even
though when this program starts running
main is using this chunk of memory at
the bottom in the so-called stack and
the stack is just like a cafeteria stack
of trays it grows up like this here's
Maine's memory on the stack here's the
swap functions memory on the stack it's
using three ins instead of two instead
of only two
what happens when the function returns
whether it's void or not the sort of
recollection that this is swaps memory
goes away and garbage values are left so
adorably we get rid of these values here
and there's still data there technically
the numbers 1 1 and 2 are still there in
the computer's memory but they no longer
belong to us because the function has
now returned so they're still in there
and this is kind of an example visually
of why there's other stuff in memory
even though you didn't put it there
necessarily sometimes you did put it
there but now once swap returns you only
should be touching memory inside of main
but we've never actually copied one
value
into Maine we haven't returned anything
and we haven't solved this fundamentally
so how could we do this well what if we
instead passed into swap not copies of X
and Y calling them A and B what if they
passed in breadcrumbs to X and Y sort of
a Treasures map that will lead swap to
the actual X and to the actual y today
we have that capability using pointers
so suppose that we use this code instead
there's a lot of stars going on here
which is a bit annoying but let's
consider what it is we're trying to
achieve what if we pass in not X and Y
but the address of X and the address of
Y respectively breadcrumbs if you will
that will lead swap to the original
values then what we do is we still give
ourselves a temp variable Like An Empty
Glass it's still a glass so we still
call it an INT but what do we want to
put into that temporary variable we
don't want to put a into it because
that's an address now we want to go to
that address per the star and put
whatever's at that address what do we
then want to do well we want to then
copy into whatever's at location a we
want to copy over to location A's
contents whatever is at locations B's
contents and then lastly we want to copy
temp into whatever's at location B so
again we're very deliberately
introducing all of these stars because
we don't want to change any of these
addresses we want to go to these
addresses per the dereference operator
and put values there or get values from
so what does this actually mean well if
I kind of rewind in this story and I go
back here I still have temp although I'm
going to delete its value to begin with
I still have uh
B and I still have a but what's going to
be different this time is how I use a
and b so let me finish erasing those
that's a on the left this is B on the
right at this point in the story we're
re-running swap with this new and
improved version and let's see what
happens well
X is presumably at some address maybe
it's like
ox123 as always what then does a get
when I'm using this code the value of a
is
ox123 what is the value of B maybe y is
at Ox four five six what goes in B well
I'm going to put Ox four five six and
then what am I going to do based on
these three lines of code I'm going to
store in temp whatever is at the address
in a what is the address in a that's
this thing here so I'm going to put 1 in
temp line two I'm going to go to B all
right B is four five six so I'm going to
B and I'm going to store 2 at whatever
is at location a and at location a is
one two three so that's this so what am
I going to do I'm going to change this
one to a 2.
last line of code get the value of temp
which is one and then put it at whatever
the location B is so B four five six go
there and change it to be the value of
temp TMP which puts one here that's it
for the code there's still no return
value swap returns which means these
three temporary variables are sort of
garbage values now that can be reused by
subsequent function calls but now I've
actually swapped the values of X and Y
which is to say what came as naturally
as the real world here is for Mariana is
not quite as simply done in C because
again functions are sort of isolated
from each other you can pass in values
but you get copies of those values if
you want one function to affect the
value of a variable somewhere else
you have to one understand what's going
on but two pass things in as by a
pointer here so if I go back to my code
here I need to make a few changes now
let me get rid of these extra printfs
let me go in and add all these Stars
so I'm dereferencing these actual
addresses
here and here and I've got to make one
more change
how do I now call swap
if swap is expecting an instar and an
instar that is the address of an INT and
the address of another int what do I
change on line 11 here yeah
sorry a little ladder
sorry the the address of operator so up
here on line 11 we do Ampersand X and
Ampersand y so that yes we're
technically passing in a copy of a value
but this time the copy we're passing in
is technically an address and as soon as
we have an address just like when I held
up the fuzzy finger or the foamy finger
I can point at that address I can go to
that address and actually get a value
from the mailbox or put a value into the
mailbox if I even want so let's cross
our fingers now and do make
swap enter oh my God so many mistakes oh
I didn't remember to change my prototype
so let me go way up here and add two
more stars because I made that change
already make swap dot slash Swap and
voila now I have actually swapped thank
you
thank you the two values all right so
what more can we do here well let me
consider that
all this time we've been deliberately
using get string and get int and get
float and so forth but for a reason
these aren't just training wheels for
the sake of like making things easier
they're actually in place to make your
code safer and to illustrate this let me
go ahead and open up one other file here
how about a file called uh code uh
scanf.c it turns out that the old school
way the way and see really of getting
user input is via functions like scanf
and let me go ahead and include standard
io.h int main void and without using the
cs50 library at all for Strings or for
any of those get functions let me give
myself an INT called X let me just print
out what the value of x is even though
it's going to be um or rather ask the
user for the value by asking them for x
and I'm going to use a function called
scanf that's going to scan in an integer
using percent I and I'm going to store
whatever the human types in at this
location and then I'm going to go ahead
and just so we can see what happened I'm
going to print out with percent I
whatever the human typed in as follows
all right so line 8 is week one style
code line 5 and 6 is week one style code
so the Curiosity today is this new line
scanf is another function in
standardio.h and notice what I'm doing
I'm using the same syntax that I use for
printf which is kind of a little clue a
format code to tell scan F what it is I
want to scan in that is read from the
human's keyboard and I'm telling it
where to put whatever the human typed in
I can't just say x because we run into
the same darn problem as with swap I
have to give a little breadcrumb to the
variable where I want scanf to put the
human's integer and so this just tells
the computer to get an INT this is what
you would have had to type essentially
in week one just to get an INT from the
user and there's a whole bunch of things
that can go wrong still but that's the
cryptic syntax we would have had to show
you in week one let me go ahead and make
scan F here oops uh
user error put the semicolon in the
wrong place make scan F enter oh my God
uh non-void doesn't return a value
oh thank you
strike two okay make scan F there we go
okay so scan F I'm going to type in a
number like 50 and it just prints it
back out so that is the sort of
traditional way of implementing
something like get int the problem
though is when you start to get into
Strings things get dangerous quickly let
me get delete all of this and give
myself a string s although wait a minute
we don't call it strings anymore Char
star to store a string then let me go
ahead and just prompt the user for a
string using just printf then let me go
ahead and use scanf ask them for a
string this time with percent s and
store it at that address then let me go
ahead and print out whatever the human
typed in just by using the same notation
so here line five is the same thing as
string s but we've taken back that layer
today so it's Char star s this is just
week one this is just week one line
seven is new scanf will also read from
the human's keyboard a string and store
it at s but that's okay because s is an
address it's correct not to do the
Ampersand it's not necessary a string is
and has always been a Char star AKA
string
the problem though arises as follows if
I do make scan f
oh my god oh uh I can't okay we have
certain defenses in place with make let
me do clang of scan f
dot C and output a program called scanf
all right so I'm overriding some of our
pedagogical defenses that we have in
place with make let me now run scanf of
this version enter and let me type in
something like uh how about hi again
huh
so it didn't even store something and it
weirdly printed out no this time it's in
lower case but that is somewhat related
what did I fundamentally do wrong though
here
why is this getting more and more
dangerous and let me illustrate the
point even more what if I type in not
just something like hello which also
doesn't work what if I do like hello and
make a really long string enter
that still works let's kind of do this
again
let's try again
right a really long unexpectedly long
string this is the non-determinism
kicking it enter all right damn it I was
trying to trigger a segmentation fault
but it wouldn't uh but the point Still
Remains it's still not working but
what's the essence of Y
this isn't working and it's not storing
my actual input yeah
we have to make space for it so what
we're missing here is malloc or
something like that so I I could do that
I could do something like this well let
me let the human type in at least a
three letter word so I could do malloc
of three plus one for the new for the
null character so like let me give them
four characters and let me go ahead and
do make scan F whoops uh nope sorry
clang I have to Circ nope damn it oh
include standard lib dot h
there we go that gives me malloc now I'm
going to recompile this with clang now
I'm going to rerun it and now I'm going
to type in my first thing hi that now
works and let me get a little aggressive
now and type in hello which is too long
still works but I'm getting lucky let me
try it hello
damn it that still works too
sort of but it actually not quite
there's some weirdness going on there
already it turns out I can also do this
I could actually just say Char star star
4 and give myself an array of four
characters let me try this one more time
so let me rerun clang
dot slash scanf hello clearly exceeding
the four characters
there we go thank you all right so
the the point here though is if we
hadn't given you get int you would have
had to use the Scana thing not a huge
deal because it seemed to work but if we
hadn't given you get string you would
have had to do stuff like this knowing
about malloc already or knowing about
strings being erased and even now
there's a danger if the human types in
five letters six letters a hundred
letters this code like with the hello
input will probably just crash which is
bad so get string also has this
functionality built in where we have a
fancy Loop inside such that we allocate
using Matlock as many bytes as you
physically type in and we use malloc
essentially every keystroke the moment
you type in
h-e-l-l-o we're sort of like laying the
tracks as we go and we keep allocating
more and more memory so that we
theoretically will never crash with get
string even though it's this easy to
crack this easy to crash your code using
scanf if you again did it without the
help of a library so where are we all
going with this well let me show you a
few final examples that'll pave the way
for what will be problem set for let me
go ahead and open up from today's code
which is available on the course's
website for instance a program like this
called phonebook.c and I'm just going to
give you a quick tour of it that you'll
see more details on in the context of
preset 4 itself we're going to introduce
a few new functions you're going to see
you're going to see a function called f
open which stands for file open and it
takes two arguments the name of a file
to open like a CSV that you might
manipulate in Excel or Google
spreadsheets or the like comma separated
values and then something like a for
append R for read W for right depending
on whether you want to add to the file
just open it up or change it we're going
to introduce you to a file pointer
you'll see that Capital file which is a
little non-conventional Capital file is
a pointer to an actual file on the
computer's hard drive so that you can
actually access something like a CSV
file or heck even images and we're going
to see down below that you're also going
to have the ability to write files as
well or print to files you'll see
functions like printf printf for file
printf or F right file right which now
that you will begin to understand
pointers you'll have the ability ability
to actually not only read files text
files images other things but also write
them out in fact for instance just as a
teaser here jpegs will be one of the
things we focus on this week where we
give you a forensic image and your goal
is to recover as many photographs from
this forensic image of like a digital
camera as you possibly can and the way
you're going to do that is by knowing in
advance that every jpeg in the world
starts with these three bytes written in
hexadecimal but these three numbers and
so in fact just as a teaser let me open
up an example you'll see on the courses
website for today if I scroll through
here you'll see a program that does a
little something like this and again
more on this and if we could hit the
button oh there we go so here we have
um the notion of a byte we're going to
create for ourselves we'll see a data
type called byte which is a common
convention this gives me three bytes and
you're going to learn about a function
called f read which reads from a file
some number of bytes for instance three
bytes we might then use code like this
if bytes bracket zero equals equals oxf
and bytes bracket one equals 0x d8 and
bytes bracket two equals zero xff all
three of those bytes I just claim to
represent a JPEG you'll see an output
like this let me go ahead and run this
program as follows let me copy jpeg.c
into my directory from today's
distribution let me do make jpeg
and let me run jpeg on a file which is
available online called lecture.jpg and
I claim yes it's possibly a JPEG well
what is that file let me open it up for
us called lecture.jpg and here for
instance is that same photo with which
we began class namely implemented as a
JPEG but what we're also going to do
this week is start to implement our own
sort of filters a la Instagram whereby
we might take images and actually run
them through a program that creates
different versions thereof for instance
using a different file format called BMP
which essentially lays out all of its
pixels from left to right top to bottom
in a grid you're going to see a struct a
data structancy that's way more
complicated than like the candidate
structure from the past or the person
structure from the past that looks like
this which is just a whole bunch more
values in it but we'll walk you through
these in the pset and we might take a
photograph like this and ask you to run
a few different filters on it all on
Instagram like a black and white filter
or grayscale a CPA filter to give it
some old school field or a reflection
like this to an invert it or blur it
even in this way and just to end on a
note here I have a version of this code
ready to go that doesn't Implement all
of those filters it just implements one
filter initially let me go ahead and
just ready this on my computer here I'm
going to go into my own version of
filter and you'll see a few files that
will give you a tour of this coming week
in bitmap.h for instance is a version of
this structure that I claimed existed a
moment ago and let me show you this file
here
helpers.c in which there is
a function called filter that I've
already implemented in advance today but
the ones we give you for the piece that
won't already be implemented this
function called filter takes the height
of an image the width of an image and a
two-dimensional array so rows and
Columns of pixels and then I have a loop
like this that iterates over all of the
pixels in an image from top to bottom
left to right and then notice what I'm
going to do here I'm going to change the
blue value to be zero in this case and
the green value to be zero in this case
but why well the image I have here in
mind is this one whereby we have this
hidden image that simply has sort of old
school style a secret message embedded
in it and if you don't happen to have in
your dorm like one of these sort of
secret decoder glasses that essentially
make everything red getting rid of the
Green in the world and the blue in the
world you can actually I'm actually
probably the only one who can read this
right now see what messages hidden
behind all of this red noise but if
using my code written here in helpers.c
I get rid of all the blue in the picture
and I get rid of all the Green in the
picture essentially implementing the
idea of this filter this red filter
where you only see red well let's go
ahead and compile this program make
filter run dot slash filter on this
hiddenmessage.bmp I'm going to save it
in a new file called message.bmp and
with one final flourish we're going to
open up message.bmp which is the result
of having put on these glasses and
hopefully now you too will see what I
see
foreign
all right that's it for cs50 we'll see
you next time
[Music]
foreign
this is cs50 and this is already week
five which means this is actually our
last week in C together in fact in just
a few days time what has looked like
this and much more cryptic than this
perhaps is going to be distilled into
something much simpler next week when we
transition to a language called Python
and with python we'll still have our
conditionals and loops and functions and
so forth but a lot of like the low level
Plumbing that you might have been
wrestling with struggling with
frustrated by over the past couple of
weeks especially now that we've
introduced pointers and it feels like
you probably have to do everything
yourself in Python and in a lot of
higher level languages so to speak more
modern more recent languages you'll be
able to do so much more with just single
lines of code and indeed we're going to
start leveraging libraries all the more
code that other people wrote uh
Frameworks which is collections of
libraries that other people wrote and on
top of all that will you be able to make
even better or grander more impressive
projects that actually solve problems of
particular interest to you particularly
by way of your own final project
so last week though in week four recall
that we focused on memory and we've been
treating this memory inside of your
computers kind of like a canvas right at
the end of the day it's just zeros and
ones or bytes really and it's really up
to you what you do with those bytes and
how you interconnect them how you
represent information on them and arrays
were like one of the simplest ways we
started playing around with that memory
just contiguous chunks of memory back to
back to back but let's consider for a
moment some of the problems that pretty
quickly arise with arrays and then today
focus on what more generally are called
data structures using your computer's
memory as a much more versatile canvas
to create even two dimensional
structures to represent information and
ultimately to solve more interesting
problems so here's an array of size
three maybe the size of three integers
and suppose that this is inside of a
program and at this point in the story
you've got three numbers in it already
one two and three and suppose whatever
the context you need to now add a fourth
number to this array like the number
four well instinctively where should the
number four go if this is your
computer's memory and we currently have
this array one two three from what left
to right
where should the number four just
perhaps naively go yeah what do you
think
sorry
oh okay so you could replace number one
I don't really like that though because
I'd like to keep number one around but
that's an option but I'm losing of
course information so what else could I
do if I want to add the number four over
there
yeah so I mean it feels like if there's
some ordering to these which seems kind
of a reasonable inference that it
probably belongs somewhere over here but
recall last week as we started poking
around a computer's memory there's other
stuff potentially going on and if we
sort of fill that in ideally we'd want
to just plop the number four here if
we're maintaining this kind of order but
recall in the context of your computer's
memory there might be other stuff there
some of these garbage values that might
be usable but we don't really know or
care what they are as represented by
Oscar here but there might actually be
useful data in use like if your program
has not just a few integers in this
array but also a string that says like
Hello World it could be that your
computer has plopped the
h-e-l-l-o-w-o-r-l-d right after this
array why well maybe you created the
array in one line of code and filled it
with one two three maybe the next line
of code used get string or maybe just
hard-coded a string in your code for
hello world and so you kind of painted
yourself into a corner so to speak now I
think you might claim well let's just
overwrite the H but that's kind of
problematic for the the same reasons we
don't want to do that
so where else could the four go or how
do we solve this problem if we want to
add a number and there's clearly memory
available because those garbage values
are junk that we don't care about
anymore so we could certainly reuse
those
where could the four and perhaps this
whole array go
okay so I'm hearing we could move it
somewhere maybe replace some of those
garbage values and honestly we kind of
have a lot of options we could use any
of these garbage values up here we could
use any of these down here or even
further down the point is there is
plenty of memory available as indicated
by these Oscars where we could put four
maybe even five six or more integers the
catch is that we sort of chose poorly
early on or we just got unlucky and one
two three ended up back to back with
some other data that we care about all
right so that's fine let's go ahead and
assume that we'll abstract away
everything else and we'll plop the new
array in this location here so I'm going
to go ahead and copy the one over the
two over the three over and then
ultimately once I'm ready to fill the
four I can throw away essentially the
old array at this point because I have
it now entirely in duplicate and I can
populate it with the number four all
right so problem solved that is a
correct potential solution to this
problem but what's the trade-off and
this is something we're going to start
thinking about all the more what's the
downside of having solved this problem
in this way yeah
yeah I'm adding a lot of running time it
took me a lot of effort to copy those
additional numbers now granted it's a
small array three numbers who cares it's
going to be over in the blink of an eye
but if we start talking about
interesting data sets sort of uh web
application data sets mobile app data
sets where you have not just a few but
maybe a few hundred a few thousand a few
million pieces of data this is probably
kind of a sub-optimal solution to just
oh move all your data from one place to
another because who's to say that we're
not going to paint ourselves into a new
corner and it would feel like you're
wasting all of this time moving stuff
around and ultimately just costing
yourself a huge amount of time in fact
if we put this now into the context of
our Big O notation from a few weeks back
what might the running time now of
search be for an array let's start
simple I'll throw back a couple of weeks
ago if you're using an array to recap
what was the running time of a search
algorithm in Big O notation so maybe in
the worst case
if you've got n numbers 3 in this case
or four but N More generally they go of
what for search
yeah what do you think
Big O of N and what's your intuition for
that
[Music]
okay yeah so if we go through each
element for instance from left to right
then search is going to take us Big O
notation a big O running time if though
we're talking about these numbers
specifically and now I'll explicitly
stipulate that yeah they're sorted does
that bias anything what would the Big O
notation be for searching an array in
this case be it of size three or four or
N More generally
big goal of not end but rather login
right because we could use per week zero
binary search on an array like this we'd
have to deal with some rounding because
there's not a perfect number of elements
at the moment but you could use binary
search go to the middle roughly and then
go left or right left or right until you
find the element you care about so
search remains in Big O of log and when
using arrays but what about insertion
now if we start to think about other
operations like adding a number to this
array or adding a friend to your
contacts app or Google finding another
page on the internet so insertion
happens all the time what's the running
time of insert
when it comes to inserting into an
existing array of size n how many steps
might that take
Big O of n it would be indeed n why
because in the worst case where you're
sort of out of space you have to
allocate it would seem a new array maybe
taking over some of the previous garbage
values but the catch is even though
you're only inserting one new number
like the number four you have to copy
over all the darn existing numbers into
the new one so if your original array is
size n the copying of that is going to
take Big O of n plus one but we can
throw away the plus one because the math
we did in the past so insert now becomes
Big O of N and that might not be ideal
because if you're in the habit of
inserting things frequently that could
start to add up and add up and add up
and this is why computer programs and
websites and mobile apps could be slow
if you're not being mindful of these
kinds of trade-offs so what about uh
just for good measure uh Omega notation
and maybe the best case well just to
recap here we could get lucky and search
could just take one step because you
might just get lucky and boom the number
you're looking for is right there in the
middle if using binary search or even
linear search for that matter and in or
two if there's enough room and we didn't
have to move all of those numbers one
two and three to a new location you
could get lucky and we could have a
someone suggested just put the number
four right there at the end and if we
don't get lucky it might take end steps
if we do get lucky it might just take
the one or constant number of steps in
fact let me go ahead and do this how
about we do something like this let me
switch over to some code here let me
start to make a program called list.c
and in list.c let's start with the old
way so we kind of follow our the
breadcrumbs we've laid for ourselves as
follows so in this list.c I'm going to
include standardio.h int main void as
usual then inside of my code here I'm
going to go ahead and give myself the
first version of memory so int list
three is now implemented at the moment
in an array so we're rewinding for now
to week two style code and then let me
just initialize this thing at the first
location will be one at the next
location will be two and at the last
location will be three so the array is
zero indexed always I for just a the
sake of discussion though and putting in
the numbers one two three like a normal
person might all right so now let's just
print these out four into I get zero I
less than three I plus plus let's go
ahead now and print out using printf
percent I backslash n list bracket I so
very simple program kind of inspired by
what we did in week two just to create
and then print out the context of an
array so let's make list
so far so good dot slash list and voila
we see one two three now let's start to
practice some of what we're preaching
with this new syntax so let me go in now
and get rid of the array version and let
me zoom out a little bit to give
ourselves some more space and now let's
begin to create a list of size three so
if I'm going to do this now dynamically
so that I'm allocating these things
again and again
let me go ahead and do this let me give
myself a list
that's of type instar
equal the return value of malloc of
three times whoops three times the size
of an INT so what this is going to do
for me is give me enough memory for that
very first picture we drew on the board
which was the array containing one two
and three but laying the foundation to
be able to resize it which was
ultimately the goal so my syntax is a
little different here I'm going to use
malloc and get memory from the so-called
Heap as we called it last week instead
of using the stack by just doing the
previous version where I said int list
three that is to say this line of code
from the first version is in some sense
identical to this line of code in the
second version but the first line of
code puts the memory on the stack
automatically for me the second line of
code that I've left here now is creating
an array of size three but it's putting
it on the Heap and that's important
because it was only on the Heap and Via
this new function last week malloc that
you can actually ask for more memory and
even give it back when you just use the
first notation int list three you have
permanently given yourself an array of
size three you can not add to that in
code so let me go ahead and do this if
list equals equals null something went
wrong the computer's out of memory so
let's just return one and quit out of
this program there's nothing to see here
so just a good error check there now let
me go ahead and initialize this list so
list bracket 0 will be one again list
bracket one will be two and list bracket
two will be three so that's the same
kind of syntax as before and notice this
equivalence recall that there's this
relationship between chunks of memory
and arrays and arrays are really just
doing pointer arithmetic for you or the
square bracket notation is so if I've
asked myself here in line five for
enough memory for three integers it is
perfectly okay to treat it now like an
array using square bracket notation
because the computer will do the
arithmetic for me and find the first
location the second and the third if you
really want to be kind of cool and
hacker like well you could say list
equals one list plus one equals two list
plus two equals three that's the same
thing using very explicit pointer
arithmetic which we looked at briefly
last week but this is atrocious to look
at for most people it's just not very
user friendly it's longer to type so
most people even when allocating memory
dynamically as I did a second ago would
just use the more familiar notation of
an array all right so let's go on now
suppose time passes and I realize oh
shoot I really wanted this array to be
of size 4 instead of size three now
obviously I could just rewind and like
fix the program but suppose that this is
a much larger program and I've realized
at this point that I need to be able to
dynamically add more things to this
array for whatever reason well let me go
ahead and do this let me just say all
right list should actually be the result
of asking for four
uh chunks of memory for malloc and then
I could do something like this uh list
bracket 3 equals four
now this is buggy potentially in a
couple of ways but let me ask first
what's really wrong first with this code
the goal at hand is to start with the
array of size three with the one two
three and I want to add a number four to
it so at the moment in line 17 I've
asked the computer for a chunk of four
integers just like the picture and then
I'm adding the number four to it but I
kind of have skipped a few steps and
broken this somehow yeah
[Music]
yeah I don't necessarily know where this
is going to end up in memory it's
probably not going to be immediately
adjacent to the previous chunk and so
yes even though I'm putting the number
four there I haven't copied the one the
two or the three over to this chunk of
memory so well let me fix well that's
actually indeed really the essence of
the problem I am orphaning the original
chunk of memory if you think of the
picture that I drew earlier the line of
code up here on line five that allocates
space for the initial three integers
this code is fine this code is fine but
as soon as I do this I'm clobbering the
value of list and saying no no don't
point at this chunk of memory point it
this chunk of memory at which point I've
forgotten if you will where the original
chunk of memory is so the right way to
do something like this would be a little
more involved let me go ahead and give
myself a temporary variable and I'll
literally call it temp TMP kind of like
I did last week so that I can now ask
the computer for a completely different
chunk of memory size four I'm gonna
again say if temp equals null I'm going
to say oh bad things happened here so
let me just return one and you know what
just to be tidy let me free the original
list before I quit because remember from
last week anytime you use malloc you
eventually have to use free but this
chunk of code here is just a safety
check if there's no more memory there's
nothing to see here I'm just going to
clean up my state and quit but now if I
have asked for this chunk of memory now
I can do this for INT I get whoops for
INT I get zero I is less than three I
plus plus what if I do something like
this temp bracket I equals list bracket
I that would seem to have the effect of
copying all of the memory from one to
the other and then I think I need to do
one last thing temp bracket three gets
the number four for instance again I'm
kind of just hard coding the numbers for
the sake of discussion
after I've done this what could I now do
I could Now set list equals to temp
and now I have updated my linked list
properly so let me go ahead and do this
for INT I get zero I is less than 4 I
plus plus let me go ahead and print each
of these elements out with percent I
using list bracket I and then I'm going
to return 0 just to signify that all is
successful now so to recap we initialize
the original array of size three and
plug in the values one two three
time passes and then I realized wait a
minute I need more space and so I asked
the computer for a second chunk of
memory this one of size four just as a
safety check I make sure that temp
doesn't equal null because if it does
I'm out of memory so I should just quit
all together but once I'm sure that it's
not null I'm going to copy all the
values from the old list into the new
list
and then I'm going to add my new number
at the end of that list and then now
that I'm done playing around with this
temporary variable I'm going to remember
in my list variable what the addresses
of this new chunk of memory and then I'm
going to print all of those values out
so at least aesthetically when I make
this new version of my list except for
my missing semicolon let me try this
again when I make list okay what I do
this time implicitly declaring a library
function malloc dot dot dot what's my
mistake anytime you see that kind of
error
yeah a library so up here I forgot to do
include standard lib dot h which is
where malloc lives let me go ahead and
again do make list there we go so I
fixed that dot slash list and I should
see one two three four
but there's still a bug here
does anyone see the bugger question
oh sorry say again
I forgot to free the original list and
we could see this even if not just with
our own eyes or intuition if I do
something like Val grind of dot slash
list remember our tool from this past
week let me increase the size of my
terminal window temporarily the output
is crazy cryptic at first but notice
that I have definitely lost some number
of bytes here and indeed it's even
pointing at the line number in which
some of those bytes were lost so let me
go ahead and back to my code and indeed
I think what I need to do is before I
clobber the value of list pointing it at
this new chunk of memory instead of the
old I think I now need to First
proactively say free the old list of
memory and then change its value so if I
now do make list and do dot slash list
the output is still the same and if I
cross my fingers and run valgrind again
after increasing my window size
hopefully here
ah still a bug so better it seems like
less memory is lost
what have I now forgotten to do
I forgot to free it at the very end too
because I still have a chunk of memory
that I got from malloc so let me go to
the very bottom of the program now and
after I'm done sort of uh sort of
senselessly just printing this thing out
let me free the new list
and now let me do make list dot slash
list it still works visually now let's
do valgrind of
dot slash list enter and now hopefully
all Heap blocks were freed no leaks are
possible so this is perhaps the best
kind of output you can see from a tool
like valgrin I use the Heap but I freed
all the memory as well so there were two
fixes needed there are any questions
then on this array-based approach the
first of which is statically allocating
an array so to speak by just hard coding
the number three this second version now
is dynamically allocating the array
using not the stack but the Heap but it
too suffers from the slowness we
described earlier of having to copy all
those values from one to the other okay
I'll hand was over here
[Music]
good question why did I not have to free
the temp I essentially did eventually
because temp was pointing at the chunk
of four integers but on line 33 here I
assigned list to be identical to what
temp was pointing at and so when I
finally freed the list that was the same
thing as freeing temp in fact if I
wanted to I could say free temp here and
it would be the same but conceptually
it's sort of wrong because at this point
in the story I should be freeing the
actual list not that temporary variable
but they were the same at that point in
the story yeah
good question and long story short
everything we're doing thus far is still
in the world of arrays the only
distinction we're making is that in
version one when I said int list bracket
three close bracket that was an array of
fixed size so-called statically
allocated on the stack as per last week
this version now is still dealing with
arrays but I'm kind of flexing my
muscles and using dynamic memory
allocation so that I can still use an
array per the first pictures we started
talking about but I can at least grow
the array if I want so we haven't even
now solved this even better in a sense
with linked list that's going to come
next yeah
foreign
how am I able to free list I
freed the original address of list I
then changed what list is storing I'm
moving its Arrow to a new chunk of
memory and that is perfectly reasonable
for me to now manipulate because now
list is pointing at the same value of
Temp and temp is what was given the
return value of malloc the second time
so that chunk of memory is valid so
these are just
um you know squares on the board right
there's just pointers inside of them so
what I'm technically saying is I'm not
pointing I'm not freeing list per se I
am freeing the chunk of memory that
begins at the address currently enlist
therefore if a few lines later I change
what the address is in list totally
reasonable to then touch that memory and
eventually free it later because you're
not freeing the variable per se you're
freeing the address in the variable good
distinction all right so let me back up
here and just now make one final edit so
let's finish this with one final
Improvement here because it turns out
there's a somewhat better way to
actually resize an array as we've been
doing here and there's another function
in standard lib that's called realloc
for reallocate and I'm just going to go
in and make a little bit of a change
here so that I can do the following let
me go ahead and first comment this now
just so we can keep track of what's been
going on this whole time so dynamically
allocate an array of size three
assign three numbers to that array
time passes
allocate new array of size four
[Music]
copy numbers from old array into new
array
and add fourth number to new array
free old array
um remember if you will new array using
my same list variable and now print new
array
free new array hopefully that helps and
we'll post this code online after two
which tells a more explicit story so it
turns out that we can reduce some of the
labor involved with this not so much
with the printing here but with this
copying turns out C does have a function
called realloc that can actually handle
the resizing of an array for you as
follows I'm going to scroll up to where
I previously allocated a new array of
size four and I'm instead going to say
this
resize old array to be of size 4. now
previously this wasn't necessarily
possible because recall that we had
painted ourselves into a corner with the
example on the screen where hello world
happened to be right after the original
array but let me do this let me use
re-alloc for reallocate and pass in not
just the size of memory we want this
time but also the address that we want
to resize which again is this array
called list
all right the code thereafter is pretty
much the same but what I don't need to
do
is this so re-adlock is a pretty handy
function that will do the following if
at the very beginning of class when we
had one two three on the board and
someone's Instinct was to just plop the
four right at the end of the list if
there's available memory realc will just
do that and boom it will just grow the
array for you in the computer's memory
if though it realizes sorry there's also
there's already a string like hello
world or something else there re-adlock
will handle the trouble of moving that
whole array from one chunk of memory
originally to a new chunk of memory and
then realock will return to you the
address of that new chunk of memory and
it will handle the process of freeing
the old chunk for you so you do not need
to do this yourself so in fact let me go
ahead and get rid of this as well
so re-alak just condenses a lot of what
we just did into a single function
whereby
realock handles it for you all right so
that's the final Improvement on this
array-based approach so what now knowing
what your memory is what can we now do
with it that solves that kind of problem
because the world is going to get really
slow in our apps and our phones and our
computers are getting it really slow if
we're just constantly wasting time
moving things around in memory what
could we perhaps do instead well there's
just one new piece of syntax today that
builds on these three pieces of syntax
from the past recall that we've looked
at struct which is a keyword in C that
just lets you invent your own structure
your own variable if you will in
conjunction with type def which lets you
say a person has a name and a number or
something like that or a candidate it
has a name and some number of votes you
can encapsulate multiple pieces of data
inside of just one using struct what did
we use the dot notation for now a couple
times
what does the dot operator do in C
and
perfect to access the field inside of a
structure so if you've got a person with
a name and a number you could say
something like person.name or
person.number if person is the name of
one such variable star of course we've
seen now in a few ways like way back in
week one we saw it as like
multiplication uh last week we began to
see it in the context of pointers
whereby you use it to declare a pointer
like int star P or something like that
but we also saw it in one other context
which was like the opposite which was
the dereference operator which says if
this is an address that is if this is a
variable like a pointer and you put a
star in front of it then with no int or
no char No data type in front of it that
means go to that address and it
dereferences the pointer and goes to
that location so it turns out that using
these three building blocks you can
actually start to now use your
computer's memory almost any way you
want and even next week when we
transition to Python and you start to
get a lot of features for free like a
single line of code will just do so much
more in Python than it does in C it
boils down to those basic Primitives and
just so you've seen it already it turns
out that it's so common in C to use this
operator to go inside of a structure and
this operator to go to an address that
there's shorthand notation for it AKA
syntactic sugar that literally looks
like an arrow so recall last week I was
in the habit of pointing even with the
big foam finger this arrow notation a
hyphen and a angled bracket denotes
going to a an address and looking at a
field inside of it but we'll see this in
practice in just a bit
so what might be the solution now to
this problem we saw a moment ago whereby
we had painted ourselves into a corner
and our memory a few moments ago looked
like this we could just copy the whole
existing array to a new location add the
four and go about our business what
would another perhaps better solution
longer term be that doesn't require
constantly moving stuff around
and maybe hang in there for your
instincts if you know the sort of Buzz
phrase we're looking for from past
experience hang in there
but if we want to avoid moving the one
two and the three but we still want to
be able to add endless amounts of data
what could we do
yeah so maybe create some kind of list
using pointers that just kind of point
at a new location right in an ideal
world even though this uh piece of
memory is being used by this H in the
string hello world maybe we could
somehow use a pointer from last week
like an arrow that says after the three
oh I don't know go down over here to
this location in memory and you just
kind of stitch together these integers
in memory so that each one leads to the
next it's not necessarily the case that
it's literally back to back that would
have the downside it would seem of
costing us a little bit of space like a
pointer which recall takes up some
amount of space typically eight bytes or
64 bits but I don't have to copy
potentially a huge amount of data just
to add one more number and so these
things do have a name and indeed these
things are what generally would be
called a
linked list a linked list captures
exactly that kind of intuition of
linking together things in memory so
let's take a look at an example here's
computer's memory in the abstract
suppose that I'm trying to create an
array no let's generalize it as a list
now of numbers an array has a very
specific meaning it's memory that's
contiguous back to back to back at the
end of the day I as the programmer just
care about the data one two three four
and so forth I don't really care how
it's stored until uh I don't care how
it's stored when I'm writing the code I
just want it to work at the end of the
day so suppose that I first insert my
number one and who knows it ends up up
there at location ox123 for the sake of
discussion all right maybe there's
something already here and heck maybe
there's something already here but
there's plenty of other options for
where this thing can go and suppose that
for the sake of discussion the first
available spot for the next number
happens to be over here at uh location
Ox 456 for the sake of discussion so
that's where I'm going to plop the
number two and where might the number
three end up oh I don't know maybe down
over there at Ox 789 the point being I
don't know what is or really care about
everything else that's in the computer's
memory I just care that there are at
least three locations available where I
can put my one my two and my three but
the catch is now that we're not using an
array we can't just naively assume that
you just add one to an index and boom
you're at the next number add two to an
index and boom you're at the next next
number now you kind of have to leave
these little breadcrumbs or use the
arrow notation to kind of lead from one
to the other and sometimes it might be
close a few bytes away maybe it's a
whole gigabyte away in an even bigger
computer's memory
so how might I do this like where do
these pointers go as you proposed
right all I have access to here are
bytes I've already stored the one the
two and the three so what more should I
do
okay yeah so let me you put the pointers
right next to these numbers so let me at
least plan ahead so that when I ask the
computer like malloc recall from last
week for some memory I don't just ask it
now for space for just the number let me
start getting into the habit of asking
Matlock for enough space for the number
and a pointer to another such number so
it's a little more aggressive of me to
ask for more memory but I'm kind of
planning ahead and here's an example of
a trade-off almost any time in CS when
you start using more space you can save
time or if you try to conserve space you
might have to lose time it's being that
kind of trade-off there so how might I
solve this well let me abstract this
away and either next to or below I'm
just drawing it uh vertically just for
the sake of discussion so the arrows are
a bit prettier
I've asked malloc for now twice as much
space it would seem than I previously
needed but I'm going to use this second
chunk of memory to refer to the next
number and I'm going to use this chunk
of memory defer to the next essentially
stitching this thing together so what
should go in this first box well I claim
the number
ox456 and it's written in HEX because it
represents a memory address but this is
the equivalent of sort of drawing an
arrow from one to the other
as a little check here what should go in
this second box if the goal is to stitch
these together in order one two three
feel free to just shout this out
okay oh okay that worked well so Ox 789
indeed and you can't do that with the
hands because I can't count that fast so
ox789 should go here because that's like
a little breadcrumb to the next and then
we don't really have terribly many
possibilities here this has to have a
value right because at the end of the
day it's Gotta uh use its 64 bits in
some way so what value should go here if
this is the end of this list
so it could be 0x123 the implication
being that it would kind of be a
cyclical list which is okay but
potentially problematic if any of you
have accidentally sort of lost control
over your uh code space because you had
an infinite Loop this would seem a very
easy way to give yourself The Accidental
uh probability of an infinite Loop what
might be simpler than that and Ward that
off
say again
so just the null character not n-u-l
confusingly which is at the end of
strings but n-u-l-l as we introduced it
last week which is the same as ox0 so
this is just a special value that
programmers decades ago decided that if
you store the address is zero that's not
a valid address there's never going to
be anything useful at ox0 therefore it's
a sentinel value just a special value
that indicates that's it there's nowhere
further to go it's okay to come back to
your suggestion of making a cyclical
list but we'd better be smart enough to
maybe remember where did the list start
so that you can detect Cycles if you
start looping around in this structure
otherwise all right but these addresses
who really cares at the end of the day
if we abstract this away it really just
now looks like this and indeed this is
how most anyone would draw this on a
whiteboard if having a discussion at
work talking about what data structure
we should use to solve some problem in
the real world we don't care generally
about the addresses we care that in code
we can access them but in terms of the
concept alone this would be perhaps the
right way to think about this all right
let me pause here and see if there's any
questions on this idea of creating a
linked list in memory by just storing
not just the numbers like one two three
but twice as much data so that you have
little breadcrumbs in the form of
pointers that can lead you from one to
the next
any questions on these linked lists
any questions no all right oh yeah over
here
[Music]
this does take more memory than an array
because I now need space for these
pointers and to be clear I technically
didn't really draw this to scale thus
far in the class we've generally thought
about integers like one two and three as
being four bytes or 32 bits I made the
claim last week that on Modern computers
pointers tend to be eight bytes or 64
bits so technically this box should
actually be a little bigger it was just
going to look a little stupid in the
picture so I abstracted it away but
indeed you're using more space as a
result
oh how does the sorry how does the
computer identify useful data from uh
used data so for instance garbage values
are non-garbage values for now think of
that as the job of malloc so when you
ask malloc for memory as we started to
last week malloc keeps track of the
addresses of the memory it has handed to
you as valid values the other type of
memory you use not just from the Heap
because recall we briefly discussed that
malloc uses space from the Heap which
was drawn at the top of the picture
pointing down there's also stack memory
which is where all of your local
variables go and where all of the memory
used by individual functions go and that
was drawn in the picture is working its
way up that's just an artist's rendition
of Direction
the compiler essentially will also help
keep track of which values are valid or
not inside of the stack or really the
underlying code that you've written will
keep track of that for you so it's
managed for you at that point
all right good question sorry it took me
a bit to catch on so let's now translate
this to actual code how could we
implement this idea of let's call these
things nodes and that's a term of Art
and CS whenever you have some kind of
data structure that encapsulates
information node node is the generic
term for that so each of these might be
said to be a node well how can we do
this well a couple of weeks ago we saw
how we could represent something like a
student or a candidate and a student or
rather a person we said well has a name
and a number and we used a few pieces of
syntax here one we use the struct
keyword which gives us a data structure
we use typedef which defines the name
person to be our new data type
representing that whole structure so we
probably have the right ingredients here
to build up this thing called a node and
just to be clear what should go inside
of one of these nodes do we think it's
not going to be a name or a number
obviously but what should a node have
in terms of those fields perhaps yeah
so a number like a number and a pointer
in some form so let's translate this to
actual code so let's rename person to
node for to capture this notion here and
the number is easy if it's just going to
be an INT that's fine we can just say
int number or int n or whatever you want
to call that particular field the next
one's a little non-obvious and this is
where things get a little weird at first
but in retrospect it should all kind of
fit together let me propose that ideally
we would say something like node star
next and I could call the word next
anything I want next just means what
comes after me is the notion I'm using
it at so a lot of Cs people would just
use next to represent the name of this
pointer but there's a catch here C and C
compilers are pretty naive recall they
only look at code top to bottom left to
right and anytime they encounter a word
they have never seen before bad things
happen like you can't compile your code
you get some cryptic error message or
the like and that seems to be about to
happen here because if the compiler is
reading this code from top to bottom
it's going to say oh inside of this
struct should be a variable called Next
which is of type node star what the heck
is a node because it literally does not
find out until two lines later after
that semicolon so the way to avoid this
which we haven't quite seen before is
that you can temporarily name this whole
thing up here struct node
and then down here inside of the data
structure you say struct node star and
then you leave the rest alone this is
kind of a workaround this is possible
because now you're teaching the compiler
from the first line that here comes a
data structure called struct node down
here you're shortening the name of this
whole thing to just node why it's just a
little more convenient than having to
write struct everywhere but you do have
to write struct node star inside of the
data structure but that's okay because
it's already come into existence now as
of that first line of code so that's the
only fundamental difference between what
we did last week with a person or a
candidate we just now have to use this
this struct work around syntactically
all right yeah question
[Music]
why is the next variable a struct node
star pointer and not an instar pointer
for instance so think about the picture
we are trying to draw technically yes
each of these arrows I deliberately Drew
is pointing at the number but that's not
a loan they need to point at the whole
data structure in memory because the
computer ultimately and the compiler in
turn needs to know that this chunk of
memory is not just an INT it is a whole
node inside of a node is a number and
also another pointer so when you draw
these arrows it would be incorrect to
point at just the number because that
throws away information that would leave
the compiler wondering okay I'm at a
number where the heck is the pointer you
have to tell it that it's pointing at a
whole node so it knows a few bytes away
is that corresponding pointer good
question yeah
really good question it would seem that
just as copying the array earlier
required twice as much memory because we
copied from old to new so technically
twice as much plus one for the new
number here too it looks like we're
using twice as much memory also into my
comment earlier it's even more than
twice as much memory because these
pointers are eight bytes and not just
four bytes like a typical integer is the
differences are these in the context of
the array you were using that memory
temporarily so yes you needed twice as
much memory but then you were quickly
freeing the original array so you
weren't consuming long term more memory
than you might need the difference here
too is that as we'll see in a moment it
turns out it's going to be relatively
quick for me potentially to insert new
numbers in here because I'm not going to
have to do a huge amount of copying and
even though I might still have to follow
all of these arrows which is going to
take some amount of time I'm not going
to have to be asking for more memory
freeing more memory and certain
operations in a computer anything
involving asking for or giving back
memory tends to be slow lower so we get
to avoid that situation as well there's
going to be some downsides though this
is not all upside but we'll see in a bit
just what some of those trade-offs
actually are all right so from here if
we go back to the structure in code as
we left it let's start to now build up a
linked list with some actual code how do
you go about and see representing a
linked list in code well at the moment
it would actually be as simple as this
you declare a variable called list for
instance that itself stores the address
of a node that's what node star means
the address of a node so if you want to
store a linked list in memory you just
create a variable called list or
whatever else and you just say that this
variable is going to be pointing at the
first node in a list wherever it happens
to end up because malloc is ultimately
going to be the tool that we use just to
go get at any one particular node in
memory all right so let's actually do
this in pictorial form when you write a
line of code like I just did here and I
do not initialize it to anything with
the assignment operator an equal sign it
does exist in memory as a box as I'll
draw it here called list but I've
deliberately drawn Oscar inside of it
why to connote what exactly
it's a garbage value I have been
allocated the variable in memory called
list which is going to give me 64 bits
or 8 bytes somewhere drawn here with
this box but if I myself have not used
the assignment operator it's not going
to get magically initialized to any
particular address for me it's not going
to even give me a node this is literally
just going to be an address of a future
node that exists so what would be a
solution here suppose that I'm beginning
to create my linked list but I don't
have any nodes yet what would be a
sensible thing to initialize list two
perhaps
yeah again
so just null right when in doubt with
pointers generally it's a good thing to
initialize things to null so at least
it's not a garbage value it's a known
value invalid yes but it's a special
value you can then check for with a
conditional or the like so this might be
a better way to create a linked list
even before you've inserted any numbers
into the thing itself all right so after
that how can we go about adding
something to this linked list so now the
story looks like this Oscar is gone
because inside of this box is all zero
bits just because it's nice and clean
and this represents an empty linked list
well if I want to add the number one to
this linked list what could I do well
perhaps I could start with code like
this borrowing inspiration from last
week let's ask malloc for enough space
for the size of a node and this kind of
gets to your question earlier like what
is it I'm manipulating here I don't just
need space for an ant and I don't just
need space for a pointer I need space
for both and I gave that thing a name
node so size of node figures out and
does the arithmetic for me and gives me
back the right number of bytes this then
stores the address of that chunk of
memory in what I'll temporarily called n
just to represent a generic new node and
it's of type node star because just like
last week when I asked malloc for enough
space for an INT and I stored it in an
instar pointer this week if I'm asking
for memory for a node I'm storing it in
a node star pointer so technically
nothing new there except for this new
term of Art and data structure called
node all right so what does that do for
me it essentially draws a picture like
this in memory I still have my list
variable from my previous line of code
initialized to null and that's why I've
drawn it blank I also now have a
temporary variable called n which I
initialize to the return value of malloc
which gave me one of these nodes in
memory but I've drawn it having garbage
values too because I don't know what int
is there I don't know what pointer is
there it's garbage values because malloc
does not magically initialize memory for
me there is another function for that
but malloc alone just says sure use this
chunk of memory deal with whatever's
there so how can I go about initializing
this to known values well suppose I want
to insert the number one and then leave
it at that a list of size one I could do
something like this
and this is where you have to think back
to some of these Basics my conditional
here is asking the question if n does
not equal null so that is if malloc gave
me valid memory and I don't have to quit
altogether because my computer is out of
memory if n does not equal null that is
it equal to valid address I'm going to
go ahead and do this and this is cryptic
looking syntax now
but does someone want to take a stab at
translating this inside line of code to
English
in some sense
how might you explain what that inner
line of code is doing star n DOT number
equals one uh let me go further back
no okay over here yeah
perfect the place that n is pointing to
set it equal to one or using the
vernacular of going there go to the
address in n and set its number field to
one however you want to think about it
that's fine but the star again is the
dereference operator here and we're
doing the parentheses which we haven't
needed to do before because we haven't
dealt with pointers and data structures
together until today this just means go
there first and then once you're there
go access number you don't want to do
one thing before the other so this is
just enforcing order of operations the
parentheses just like in grade school
math all right so this line of code is
cryptic it's ugly it's not something
most people easily remember thankfully
there's that syntactic sugar that
simplifies this line of code to just
this and this even though it's new to
you today should eventually feel a
little more familiar because this now is
shorthand notation for saying start at n
go there as by following the arrow and
when you get there change the number
field in this case to one so most people
would not write code like this it's just
ugly it's a couple extra keys strokes
this just looks more like the artist's
Renditions we've been talking about and
how most CS people would think about
pointers as really just being arrows in
some form all right so what have we just
done the picture now after setting
number to one looks a little something
like this so there's still one step
missing and that's of course to
initialize it would seem the pointer in
this new node to something known like
null so I bet we could do this like this
with a different line of code I'm just
going to say if n does not equal null
then Set n is next field to null or more
pedantically go to n Follow the arrow
and then update the next field that you
find there to equal null and again this
is just doing some nice bookkeeping
technically speaking we might not need
to set this to null if we're going to
keep adding more and more numbers to it
but I'm doing it step by step so that I
have a very clean picture and there's no
bugs in my code at this point
but I'm still not done there's one last
thing I'm going to have to do here if
the goal ultimately was to insert the
number one into my linked list what's
the last step I should perhaps do here
just in English is fine yeah
[Music]
yes I now need to update the actual
variable that represents my linked list
to point at this brand new node that is
now perfectly initialized as having an
integer and a null pointer yeah
technically this is already pointing
there but I described this deliberately
earlier as being temporary I just needed
this to get it back from malloc and sort
of clean things up initially this is the
long-term variable I care about so I'm
going to want to do something simple
like this list equals n and this seems a
little weird that list equals n but
again think about what's inside this box
at the moment this is null because there
is no linked list at the beginning of
our story n is the address of the
beginning and it turns out end of our
linked list so it stands to reason that
if you set list equal to n that has the
effect of copying this address up here
or really just copying the arrow into
that same location so that now the
picture looks like this and Heck if this
was a temporary variable it will
eventually go away and now this is the
picture so kind of an annoying number of
steps certainly to walk through the
verbally like this but it's just malloc
to give yourself a node initialize the
one the second the two Fields inside of
it update the linked list and boom
you're on your way I didn't have to copy
anything I just had to insert something
in this case
or let me pause here to see if there's
any questions on those steps and we'll
see before long it all in context with
some larger code
[Music]
yes I we I drew them separately just for
the sake of the voiceover of doing each
thing very methodically in real code is
we'll transition to now I could have and
should have just done it all inside of
one conditional after checking if n is
not equal no no I could set number to a
value like one and I could set the
pointer itself to something like null
all right well let's translate then this
into some similar code that allows us to
build up a linked list now using code
similar and spirited before but now
using this new primitive so I'm going to
go back into vs code here I'm going to
go ahead and now and delete the entirety
of this old version that was entirely
array based and now inside of my main
function I'm going to go ahead and first
do this I'm going to first give myself a
uh a list of size 0 and I'm going to
call that node star list and I'm going
to initialize that to null as we
proposed earlier but I'm also now going
to have to take the additional step of
defining what this node is so recall
that I might do something like typedef
struct node inside of this struck node
I'm going to have a number which I'll
call number of type int and I'm going to
have a structure called node with a star
that says the next pointer is called
Next and I'm going to call this whole
thing more succinctly node instead of
struct node now as an aside for those of
you wondering what the difference really
is between struct and node technically I
could do something like this not use
typedef and not use the word node alone
this syntax here would actually create
for me a new data type called verbosely
struct node and I could use this
throughout my code saying struct node
struck node it just gets a little
tedious and it would be nicer just to
refer to this thing more simplistically
as a node so what typedef has been doing
for us is it again lets us invent our
own word that's even more succinct and
this just has the effect now of calling
this whole thing node without the need
subsequently to keep saying struct all
over the place just FYI all right so now
now that this thing exists in Main let's
go ahead and do this let's add a number
to list and to do this I'm going to give
myself a temporary variable I'll call it
n for consistency I'm going to use
malloc to give myself the size of a node
just like in our slides and then I'm
going to do a little safety check if n
equals equals null I'm going to do the
opposite of the slides I'm just going to
quit out of this program because there's
nothing useful to be done at this point
but most likely my computer is not going
to run out of memory so I'm going to
assume we can keep going with some of
the logic here if n does not equal null
and that is it's a valid memory address
I'm going to say n bracket I'm going to
build this up backwards well let's do
that's okay let's go ahead and do this n
bracket number equals one and then n
bracket net or Arrow next equals null
and now
uh update list to point to new node list
equals n
so at this point in the story we've
essentially constructed what was that
first picture which looks like this this
is the corresponding code via which we
built up this node in memory suppose now
we want to add the number two to the
list so let's do this again add number
add a number to list how might I do this
well I don't need to redeclare n because
I can use the same temporary variables
before so this time I'm just going to
say n equals malloc and the size of a
node I'm again going to have my safety
check so if n equals equals null then
let's just quit out of this all together
but but I have to be a little more
careful now
technically speaking what do I still
need to do before I quit out of my
program to be really proper
free the memory that did succeed a
little higher up so I think it suffices
to free what is now called list way at
the top all right now if all was well
though let's go ahead and say n bracket
number equals two and now n bracket uh
or sorry n arrow next equals null and
now let's go ahead and add it to the
list if I go ahead and do uh
list Arrow next equals N I think what
we've just done is build up the
equivalent now of this in the computer's
memory
by going to the list Fields next field
which is synonymous with the one nodes
bottom most box and store the address of
what was n which a moment ago looked
like this and I'm just throwing away in
the picture the temporary variable all
right one last thing to do let me go
down here and say add a number to list n
equals malloc let's do it one more time
size of node and clearly in a real
program we might want to start using a
loop and do this dynamically or a
function because it's a lot of
repetition now but just to go through
the syntax here this is fine if n equals
equals null out of memory for some
reason let's return one but but we
should return we should free the list
itself and even the second node list
bracket next but I've deliberately done
this poorly
all right this is a little more subtle
now and let me get rid of the
highlighting just so it's a little more
visible
if n happens to equal equal null and
something really just went wrong there
out of memory why am I freeing two
addresses now
and again it's not that I'm freeing
those variables per se I'm freeing the
addresses at in those variables
but there's also a bug with my code here
and it's subtle
let me ask more pointedly this line here
43 what is that freeing specifically can
I go to you
I'm freeing not not so that's okay I'm
not freeing lists two times technically
I'm freeing list once and list next ones
but let me just ask the more explicit
question what am I freeing with line 43
at the moment which node
I think node number one why because if
one is at the beginning of the list list
contains the address of that number one
node and so this frees that node this
line of code you might think now
intuitively okay it's probably freeing
the node number two but this is bad and
this is subtle valgrin might help you
catch this but by eyeing it it's not
necessarily obvious you should never
touch memory that you have already freed
and so the fact that I did this in this
order very bad because I'm telling the
operating system I don't know I don't
need the list address anymore do with it
what you want and then literally one
line later you're saying wait a minute
let me actually go to that address for a
moment and look at the next field of
that first node it's too late you've
already sort of given up control over
the node so it's an easy fix in this
case logically but we should be freeing
the second node first and then the first
one so that we're doing it in
essentially reverse order and again
valgrin would help you catch that but
that's the kind of thing one needs to be
be careful about when touching memory at
all you cannot touch memory after you've
freed it but here is my last step let me
go ahead and update the number field of
next number field of n to be three
the next node of n to be null and then
just like in the slide earlier I think I
can do list next next equals n and that
has the effect now of building up in the
computer's memory essentially this data
structure very manually very
pedantically like in a better world we'd
have a loop and some functions that are
automating this process but for now
we're doing it just to play around with
the syntax
so at this point unfortunately suppose I
want to print the numbers it's no longer
as easy as int I equals zero I less than
three I plus plus because you cannot
just do something like this
because pointer arithmetic no longer
comes into play when it's you who are
stitching together the data structure in
memory in all of our past examples with
arrays you've been trusting that all of
the bytes in the array are back to back
to back so it's perfectly reasonable for
the compiler and the computer to just
figure out oh well if you want bracket
zero that's at the beginning bracket one
it's one location over bracket two it's
one location over this is way less
obvious now because even though you
might want to go to the first element in
the linked list or the second or the
third you can't just jump to those
arithmetically by doing a bit of math
instead you have to follow all of those
arrows so with linked lists you can't
use this square bracket notation anymore
because one node might be here over here
over here over here you can't just use
some simple offset so I think our code
is going to have to be a little fancier
and this might look scary at first but
it's just an application of some of the
basic definitions here let me do a for
Loop that actually uses a node star
variable initialized to the list itself
I'm going to keep doing this so long as
temp does not equal null
and on each iteration of this Loop I'm
going to update temp to be whatever temp
Arrow next is and I'll rewind in a
moment and explain in more detail but
when I print something here with printf
I can still use percent I because it's
still a number at the end of the day but
what I want to print out is the number
in this temporary variable so maybe the
ugliest for Loop we've ever seen because
it's mixing not just the idea of a for
Loop which itself was a bit cryptic or
weeks ago but now I'm using pointers
instead of integers but I'm not
violating the definition of a for Loop
recall that a for Loop has three main
things in parentheses what do you want
to initialize first what condition do
you want to keep checking again and
again and what update do you want to
make on every iteration of the loop so
with that basic definition in mind this
is giving me a temporary variable called
temp that is initialized to the
beginning of the loop so it's like
pointing my finger at the number one
node then I'm asking the question does
temp not equal null well hopefully not
because I'm pointing at a valid node
that is the number one node so of course
it doesn't equal null yet null won't be
until we get to the end of the list so
what do I do I start at this temp
variable I Follow the arrow and go to
the number field therein
what do I then do the for Loop says
change temp to be whatever is at temp by
following the arrow and grabbing the
next field that then has the result of
being checked against this conditional
no of course it doesn't equal null
because the second node is the number
two node null is still at the very end
so I print out the number two next step
I update temp one more time to be
whatever is next that then does not yet
equal null so I go ahead and print out
the number three node then one last time
I update temp to be whatever temp is in
the next field but after one two three
that last next field is null and so I
break out of this for Loop all together
so if I do this in pictorial form all
we're doing if I now use my finger to
represent the temp variable I initialize
temp to be whatever list is so it points
here that's obviously not null so I
print out whatever is that temp Follow
the arrow in number and I print that out
then I update attempt to point here then
I update temp to point here then I
update temp to point here wait that's
null the for Loop ends
so again admittedly much more cryptic
than our familiar into I equals zero and
so forth but it's just a different
utilization of
the for Loop syntax
yes
[Music]
good question how is it that I'm
actually printing numbers and not
printing out addresses instead the
compiler is helping me here because I
taught it in the very beginning of my
program what a note is which looks like
this here the compiler knows that a node
has a number field and an X field down
here in the for Loop because I'm
iterating using a node star pointer and
not an INT star pointer the compiler
knows that anytime I'm pointing at
something I'm pointing at the whole node
doesn't matter where specifically in the
rectangle I'm pointing per se it's
ultimately pointing at the whole node
itself and the fact that I then use temp
Arrow number means okay adjust your
finger slightly so you're literally
pointing at the number field and not the
next field so that's sufficient
information for the computer to
distinguish
the two good question other questions
then on this approach here
yeah in the back
how would I use a for Loop to add
elements to a linked list you will do
something like this if I may in problem
set five we will give you some of the
scaffolding for doing this
um but in this coming week's materials
where we guide you to that but let me
not spoil it just yet
fair question though yeah
[Music]
okay
good question is line 49 acceptable even
if we freed it earlier we didn't free it
in line 43 in this case right you can
only reach line 49 if n does not equal
null and you do not return on line 45 so
that's safe I was only doing those
freeing if I knew on line 45 that I'm
out of here anyway at that point good
question and yeah
[Music]
correct if you're asking about temp
because it's in a for Loop does that
mean you don't have to free it you never
have to free pointers per se you should
only free addresses that were returned
to you by malloc so I haven't finished
the program to be fair but you're not
freeing variables you're not freeing
like Fields you are freeing specific
addresses whatever they may be so the
last thing and I was kind of stalling on
showing this just because it too is a
little cryptic here is how you can free
now a whole linked list in the world of
arrays recall it was so easy you just
say free list you return zero and you're
done not with a linked list because
again the computer doesn't know what you
have stitched together using all of
these pointers all over the computer's
memory you need to follow those arrows
so one way to do this would be as
follows while the list itself is not
null so while there's a list to be freed
what do I want to do I'm going to give
myself a temporary variable called temp
again and it's a different temp because
it's in a different scope it's inside of
the while loop instead of the for Loop
before a few lines earlier
I am going to initialize temp to be the
address of the next node just so I can
get one step ahead of things why am I
doing this because now I can boldly free
the list itself which does not mean the
whole list again I'm freeing the address
in list which is the address of the
number one node that's what list is it's
just the address of the number one node
so if I first use temp to point at the
number two slightly to in the middle of
the picture then it is safe for me on
line 61 at the moment to free list that
is the address of the first node now I'm
going to say all right once I freed the
first the first note in the list I can
update the list itself to be literally
temp
and now the loop repeats so what's
happening here if you think about this
picture temp is initially pointing at
not the list but list Arrow next so temp
represented by my right hand here is
pointing at the number two totally safe
and reasonable to free now the list
itself aka the address of the number one
node that has the effect of just
throwing away the number one note
telling the computer you can reuse that
memory for you the last line of code I
wrote updated list to point at the
number two at which point my Loop
proceeded to do the exact same thing
again and only once my finger is
literally pointing at nowhere the null
symbol will the loop by nature of a
while loop as I'll toggle back to break
out and there's nothing more to be freed
so again what you'll see ultimately in
problem set five more on that later is
an opportunity to play around with just
this syntax but also these ideas but
again even though the syntax is
admittedly pretty cryptic we're still
using Basics like these for Loops or
while Loops we're just starting to now
follow explicit addresses rather than
letting the computer do all of the
arithmetic
for us as we previously benefited from
at the very end of this thing I'm going
to return 0 as though all as well and I
think then
we're good to go
our questions on this linked list code
now
and again we'll walk through this again
in the coming week spec yeah
[Music]
sure can we explain this this while loop
here for freeing the list so notice that
first I'm just asking the obvious
question is the list null because
because if it is there's no work to be
done however while the list is not null
according to line 58 what do we want to
do I want to create a temporary variable
that points at the same thing that list
Arrow next is pointing at so what does
that mean here's list
list Arrow next is whatever this thing
is here so if my right hand represents
the temporary variable I'm literally
pointing at the same thing as the list
is itself the next line of code recall
was free the list and unlike in our
world of arrays like half an hour ago
where that just meant free the whole
darn list you now have taken over
control over the computer's memory with
a linked list in ways that you didn't
with the array the computer knew how to
free the whole array because you malloc
the whole thing at once you are now
mallocking the linked list one node at a
time and the operating system does not
keep track of for you where all these
nodes are so when you free list you are
literally freeing the value of the list
variable which is just this first node
here
then my last line of code which I'll
flip back to in a second updates list to
now ignore the freed memory and point at
two
and the story then repeats so again it's
just a very pedantic way of using this
new syntax of star notation and the
arrow notation and the like to sort of
do the equivalent of walking down all of
these arrows following all of these
breadcrumbs but it does take admittedly
some getting used to
syntax you only have to do one week but
again next week in Python will we begin
to abstract a lot of this complexity
away but none of this complexity is
going away it's just that someone else
the author's a python for instance will
have automated this kind of stuff for us
the goal this week is to understand what
it is we're going to get for free so to
speak next week
all right questions on these linked
lists
all right just oh yeah and back
[Music]
fair question let me summarize as could
we have freed this with a for Loop
absolutely
um it just is a matter of style it's a
little more elegant to do it in a while
loop according to me but other people
will reasonably disagree
um anything you can do with a while loop
you can do with a for Loop and vice
versa do while Loops recall are a little
different but they will always do at
least one thing but for loops and while
Loops behave the same in this case
sure other questions
all right well let's just vary things a
little bit here just to see what some of
the pitfalls might now be without
getting into the weeds of code indeed
we'll try to save some of that for
problem set five's exploration but
instead let's imagine that we want to
create a list here of our own um I can
offer an exchange for a few volunteers
uh some foam fingers to bring to the
next game perhaps uh could we get maybe
just one volunteer first come on up you
will be our linked list
from the get-go what's your name
Pedro come on up
all right thank you to Pedro
and if you wanted to stand roughly over
here but you are a null pointer so just
point sort of at the ground as though
you're pointing at zero all right so
Pedro is our linked list of size zero
which pictorially might look a little
something like this for consistency with
our past pictures now suppose that we
want to go ahead and malloc oh how about
uh the number two can we get a volunteer
to be on camera here okay you kind of
jumped out of your seat do you want to
come up
okay you really want the foam finger I
say all right round of applause sure
[Applause]
okay and what's your name
say again hey when Caleb Caleb sorry
all right so here is your number two for
your number field and here is your
pointer and come on let's say that there
was room for Caleb like right there
that's perfect so Caleb got malot if you
will over here so now if we want to
insert Caleb and the number two into
this linked list well what do we need to
do I already initialized you to two and
pointing as you are to the ground means
you're initialized to null for your next
field Pedro what you should do perfect
what's your Pedro dupe Point that's fine
too so Pedro's now pointing at the list
so now our list looks a little something
like this so so far so good all is well
so the first couple of these will be
pretty straightforward let's insert one
more if anyone really wants another foam
finger here how about make Right In The
Middle come on down
and just in anticipation how about let's
mailbox someone out okay your friends
are pointing at you do you want to come
down too preemptively this is a pool of
memory if you will what's your name
Hannah all right Hannah you are number
four
and hang there for just a moment all
right so we've just uh mallocked Hannah
and Hannah how about Hannah suppose you
ended up over there in just some random
location all right so what should we now
do if the goal is to keep these things
sorted how about so Pedro do you have to
update yourself
no all right Caleb what do you have to
do okay and Hannah what should you be
doing
I would just you're oh it's just you for
now so points at the ground representing
null okay so again demonstrating the
fact that unlike in past weeks where we
had our nice clean array back to back to
back contiguously these guys are
deliberately all over the stage so let's
Mallock another how about number five
what's your name
Jonathan all right Jonathan you are our
number five
and pick your favorite place in memory
okay
all right so Jonathan's now over there
and Hannah's over there so five we want
to point Hannah at number five so you of
course are gonna point there and where
should you be pointing down to represent
null as well okay so pretty
straightforward but now things get a
little interesting and here we'll use a
chance to without the weeds of code
point out how order of operations is
really going to matter suppose that I
next want to allocate say the number one
and I want to insert the number one into
this list yes this is what the code
would look like but if we sort of act
this out could we get one more volunteer
uh how about on the end there in the
sweater yeah come on down
we have what's your name
Lauren okay Lauren come on down
and how about Lauren why don't you go
right in here in front if you don't mind
here is your number here is your pointer
so I've initialized Lauren to the number
one and your pointer will be no pointing
at the ground uh where do you belong if
we're maintaining sorted order looks
like right at the beginning what should
happen here
okay so Pedro has presumed to point now
at Lauren
but how do you know where to point
a Pedro's undoing what he did a moment
ago so this was deliberate and that was
perfect that Pedro presumed to point
immediately at Lauren why you literally
just orphaned all of these folks all of
these chunks of memory why because if
Pedro was our only variable pointing at
that chunk of memory this is the danger
of using pointers and dynamic memory
allocation and building your own data
structures the moment you point
temporarily if you could to Lauren I
have no idea where he's pointing to I
have no idea how to get back to Caleb uh
or Hannah or anyone else on stage so
that was bad so you did undo it so
that's good I think we need Lauren to
make a decision first who should you
point at so pointing at Caleb why
because you're pointing at literally who
Pedro is pointing at Pedro now what are
you safe to do good so order of
operations there matters and if we had
just done this line of code in red here
list equals in that was like Pedro's
first instinct bad things happen and we
orphan the rest of the list but if we
think through it logically and do this
as Lauren did for us instead we've now
updated the list to look a little
something more like the this let's do
one last one we've got one more foam
finger here for the number three how
about on the end yeah you want to come
down
all right one final volunteer
all right what's your name
sorry Miriam all right so here is your
number three here's your pointer if you
want to go maybe in the middle of the
stage in a random memory location so
here too the goal is to maintain sorted
order
so let's ask the audience who or what
number should point at whom first here
so we don't screw up in orphan some of
the memory and this is if we do orphan
memory this is what's called again per
last week a memory leak your Mac your PC
your phone can start to slow down if you
keep asking for memory but never give it
back or lose track of it so we want to
get this right
who should point at whom or what number
say again
three should point at four so three do
you want to point at four
and not uh so okay good and how did you
know Miriam whom to point at
perfect okay so copying Caleb why
because if you look at where this list
is currently constructed and you can
cheat on the board here 2 is pointing to
four if you point at whoever Caleb
number two is pointing at that indeed
leads you to Hannah for number four
so now what's the next step to stitch
this together
our voice in the crowd
two to three so two to three so Caleb I
think it's now safe for you to decouple
because someone is already pointing at
Hannah we have an orphaned anyone so now
if we follow the breadcrumbs we've got
Pedro leading to one to two to three to
four to five we need the numbers back
but you can keep the foam fingers thank
you to our volunteers here
thank you
you can just put the numbers here
thank you to all so this is only to say
that when you start looking at the code
this week and the problem said it's
going to be very easy to sort of lose
sight of the forest for the trees
because the code does get really dense
but the ideas again really do bubble up
to these higher level descriptions and
if you think about data structures at
this level if you go off in program
after a class like cs50 and you're
whiteboarding something with a friend or
a colleague most people think at and
talk at this level and they just assume
that yeah if we went back and look at
our textbooks or class notes we could
figure out how to implement this but the
important stuff is the conversation and
the ideas up here even though via this
week where we get some practice with the
actual code so when it comes to
analyzing an algorithm like this let's
consider the following what might be now
the running time of operations like
searching and sorting and searching and
inserting into a linked list we talked
about arrays earlier and we had some
binary search possible ability still as
soon as it's an array but as soon as we
have a linked list these arrows like our
volunteers could be anywhere on stage
and so you can't just assume that you
can jump arithmetically to the middle
element to the middle element to middle
one you pretty much have to follow all
of these breadcrumbs again and again
so how might that inform what we see
well consider this too even though I
keep drawing all these pictures with all
of the numbers exposed and all of us
humans in the room can easily spot where
the one is where the two is where the
three is the computer again just like
with our lockers and arrays can only see
one location at a time and the key thing
with a linked list is that the only
address we've fundamentally been
remembering is what Pedro represented a
moment ago he was the link to all of the
other nodes and in turn each person led
to the next but without Pedro we would
have lost some of or all of the linked
list
so when you start with a linked list if
you want to find an element as via
search you have to do it linearly
following all of the arrows following
all of the pointers on the stage in
order to get to the node in question and
only once you hit null can you conclude
yep it was there or no it was not so
given that if a computer essentially can
only see the number one or the number
two or the number three or the number
four or the number five one at a time
how might we think about the running
time of search it is indeed Big O event
but why is that well in the worst case
the number you might be looking for is
all the way at the end and so obviously
you're going to have to search all of
the N elements and I drew these things
with boxes on top of them because again
even though you and I can immediately
see where the 5 is for instance the
computer can only figure that out by
starting at the beginning and going
there so there too is another trade-off
it would seem that overnight we have
lost the ability to do a very powerful
algorithm from week zero known as binary
search right it's gone because there's
no way in this picture to jump
mathematically to the middle node unless
you remember where it is and then
remember where every other node is and
at that point you're back to an array
linked lists by Design only remember the
next node in the list all right how
about something like insert
in the worst case perhaps how many steps
might it take to insert something into a
linked list someone else
someone else yeah
say again
N squared fortunately it's not that bad
it's not as bad as N squared that
typically means doing N Things N times
and I think we can stay under that but
not a bad
bad thought yeah
why would it be n
[Music]
okay so you're to summarize you're
proposing and because to find where the
thing goes you have to Traverse
potentially the whole list because if
I'm inserting the number six or the
number 99 that numerically belongs at
the very end I can only find its
location by looking for all of them at
this point though in the term and really
this point in the story you should start
to question these kinds of very
simplistic questions to be honest
because it the answer is almost always
going to depend right if I've just got a
linked list that looks like this the
first question back to someone asking
this question would be well does the
list need to be sorted right I've drawn
it assorted and it might imply as much
so that's a reasonable assumption to
have made but if I don't care about
maintaining sorted order I could
actually insert into a linked list in
constant time why I could just keep
inserting into the beginning into the
beginning into the beginning and even
though the list is getting longer the
number of steps required to insert
something between the first element is
not growing at all you just keep kind of
inserting inserting if you want to keep
it sorted though yes it's going to be
indeed Big O event but again these kinds
of now assumptions are going to start to
matter so let's for the sake of
discussion say it's Big O of n if we do
want to maintain sorted order but what
about um in the case of not caring it
might indeed be Big O of one and now
these are the kinds of decisions that
will start to leave to you what about in
the best case here if we're thinking
about big Omega notation then frankly we
could just get lucky in the best case
and the element we're looking for
happens to be at the beginning or heck
we just blindly insert to the beginning
irrespective of the order that we want
to keep things in all right so besides
that
how can we improve further on this
design we don't need to stop it linked
list because honestly it's not been a
clear win like linked lists allow us to
use more of our memory because we don't
need massive growing chunks of
contiguous memory so that's a win but
they still require Big O event time to
find the end of it if we care about
order we're using at least twice as much
memory for the darn pointer so that
seems like you know a side step it's not
really a step forward
so can we do better here's where we can
now accelerate the story by just
stipulating that hey even if you haven't
used this technique yet we would seem to
have an ability to stitch together
pieces of memory just using pointers and
anything you could imagine drawing with
arrows you can implement it would seem
in code so what if we leverage a second
dimension instead of just stringing
together things laterally left to right
essentially even though they were
bouncing around on the screen what if we
start to leverage a second dimension
here so to speak and build more
interesting structures in the computer's
memory well it turns out that in a
computer's memory we could create a tree
similar to a family tree if you've ever
seen or drawn a family tree with
grandparents and parents and siblings
and so forth It's kind of this uh uh you
know so inverted branch of a tree that
grows typically when it's drawn downward
instead of upward like a typical tree
but that's something we could translate
into code as well specifically let's do
something called a binary search tree
which is a type of tree and what I mean
by this is the following notice this
this is an example of an array from like
week two when we first talked about
those and we had the lockers on stage
and recall that
what was nice about an array if one it's
sorted and two all of its numbers are
indeed contiguous which is by definition
of an array we can just do some simple
math for instance if there's seven
elements in this array and we do seven
divided by two that's what three and a
half round down through truncation
that's three zero one two three that
gives me the middle element
arithmetically in this thing and even
though I have to be careful about
rounding using simple arithmetic I can
very quickly with a single line of code
or math find for you the middle of the
left half of the left half of the right
half or whatever that's the power of
arrays and that's what gave us binary
search and how did binary search work
well we looked at the middle and then we
went left or right and then we went left
or right again sort of as implied by the
this color scheme here wouldn't it be
nice if we somehow
preserved the new upsides today of
dynamic memory allocation giving
ourselves the ability to just add
another element add another element add
another element but retain the power of
binary search because log of n was much
better than n certainly for large data
sets right even the phone book
demonstrated as much weeks ago
so what if I kind of draw this same
picture in two dimensions and I preserve
the color scheme just so it's obvious
what came where
what do these things kind of look like
now
[Music]
maybe like things we might Now call
nodes right a node is just a generic
term for like storing some data what if
the data these nodes are storing are
numbers so still integers but what if we
kind of connected these cleverly like an
old family tree whereby every node has
not one pointer now but as many as two
maybe zero like in the leaves at the
bottom there in green but other nodes on
the interior might have as many as two
like having two children so to speak and
indeed the vernacular here is exactly
that this would be called the root of
the tree or this would be a parent with
respect to these children the green ones
would be grandchildren respect to these
the green ones would be siblings with
sorry these green ones would be siblings
with respect to each other and over
there too so all the same jargon you
might use in the real world applies in
the world of data structures and CS
trees
but this is interesting because I think
we could build this now this kind of
data structure in the computer's memory
how well suppose that we defined a node
to be no longer just this and no a
number in a next field what if we sort
of give ourselves a bit more room here
and give ourselves a pointer called left
and another one called right both of
which is a pointer to a struct node so
same idea as before but now we just make
sure we think of these things as
pointing this way and this way not just
this way not just a single Direction but
two so you could imagine in code
building something up like this with a
node that creates in essence this
diagram here but why is this compelling
suppose I want to find the number three
I want to search for the number three in
this tree it would seem just like Pedro
was the beginning of our linked list in
the world of trees the root so to speak
is the beginning of your data structure
you can retain and remember this entire
tree just by pointing at the root node
ultimately one variable can hang on to
this whole tree
so how can I find the number three well
if I look at the root node and the
number I'm looking for is less than
notice I can go this way or if it's
greater than I can go this way so I've
preserved that property of the phone
book or just a sorted array in general
what's true over here if I'm looking for
three I can go to the right of the two
because that number is going to be
greater if I go left it's going to be
smaller instead and here's an example of
actually recursion recursion in a
physical sense much like the Mario's
pyramid which was kind of recursively
defined notice this I claim this whole
thing is a tree specifically a binary
search tree which means every node has
two or maybe one or maybe zero children
but no more than two hence the Buy in
binary and it's the case that every left
child is smaller than the root and every
right child is larger than the root that
definition certainly works for two four
and six but it also works recursively
for every sub tree or branch of this
tree notice if you think of this as the
root it is indeed bigger than this left
child and it's smaller than this right
child and if you look even at the leaves
so to speak the grandchildren here this
root node is bigger than its left child
if it existed so it's sort of a
meaningless statement and it's it's less
than it's right child or it's not
greater than certainly so that's
meaningless too so we haven't violated
the definition even for these leaves as
well and so now how many steps does it
take to find in the worst case any
number in a binary search tree it would
seem
[Music]
so it seems too literally and the height
of this thing is actually three and so
long story short especially if you're a
little less comfy with your your
logarithms from yesteryear log base 2 is
just like the number of times you can
divide something in half and half and
half until you get down to one this is
kind of like a logarithm in the reverse
Direction here's a whole lot of elements
and we're having we're having until we
get down to one so the height of this
tree that is to say is log base 2 of n
which means that even in the worst case
the number you're looking for maybe is
all the way at the bottom in the leaves
doesn't matter it's going to take log
base 2 of n steps or log of n steps to
find maximally any one of those numbers
so again binary sorry binary search is
back
but we've paid a price
right this isn't a linked list anymore
it's a tree
but we've gained back binary search
which is pretty compelling right that's
where the whole class began on making
that distinction but what price have we
paid to retain binary search
in this new world yeah
it's no uh it's no longer sorted left to
right but this is a claim sorted
according to the binary search tree
definition where again left tree is left
child is smaller than root and right
child is greater than root so it is
sorted but it's sorted in a
two-dimensional sense if you will not
just one but another price paid
foreign
exactly every node now needs not one
number but two three pieces of data a
number and now two pointers so again
there's that kind of trade-off again
where well if you want to save time you
got to give something if you start
giving space and you start using more
space you can speed up time like you've
got it there's always a price paid and
it's very often in space or time or
complexity or developer time uh the
number of bugs you have to solve I mean
all of these are sort of finite
resources that you have to juggle among
so if we consider now the code with
which we can implement this here might
be the node and how might we actually
use something like this well let's take
a look at maybe one final program in C
here before we transition to higher
level Concepts ultimately let me go
ahead here and let me just open a
program I wrote here in advance so let
me in a moment copy over a file called
tree dot C which we'll have on the
courses website and I'll walk you
through some of the logic here that I've
written for code dots for tree dot C all
right so what do we have here first so
here is a implementation of a binary
search tree for numbers and as before
I've just kind of played around and I've
inserted the no the numbers manually so
what's going on first here is my
definition of a node for a binary search
tree copied and pasted from what I
proposed on the board a moment ago
here are two prototypes for two
functions that I'll show you in a moment
that allow me to free an entire an
entire tree one note at a time and that
also allow me to print the tree in order
so it's even though they're not sorted
left to right I bet if I'm clever about
what child I print first I can
reconstruct the idea of printing this
tree properly so how might I Implement a
binary search tree here's my main
function here is how I might represent a
tree of PSI zero it's just a null
pointer called tree
here's how I might add a number to that
list so here for instance is me
mallicking space for a node storing it
in a temporary variable called n here is
me just doing a safety check make sure n
does not equal null and then here is me
initializing this node to contain the
number two first then initializing the
left child of that node to be null and
the right child of that null node to be
null and then initializing the tree
itself to be equal to that particular
node so at this point in the story
there's just one rectangle on the screen
containing the number two with no
children
all right let's just add manually to
this a little further let's add another
number to the list by mallicking another
node I don't need to redeclare n as a
node star because it already exists at
this point here's a little safety check
I'm going to not bother with my let me
do this uh free memory here just to be
safe do I want to do this
um we'll go on a free memory too which
I've not done here but I'll save that
for another time here I'm going to
initialize the number to one I'm going
to initialize the children of this no
note to null and null and now I'm going
to do this initialize the tree's left
child to be n so what that's essentially
doing here is if this is my root node
the single rectangle I described a
moment ago that currently has no
children neither left nor right here's
my new node with the number one I want
it to become the new Left child so that
line of code on the screen there tree
left equals n is like stitching these
two together with a pointer from 2 to
the one all right the next line of code
next lines of code you can probably
guess are me adding another number to
the list just the number three so this
is a simpler tree with two one and three
respectively and this code let me wave
my hands is almost the same except for
the fact that I'm updating the tree's
right child to be this new and third
node let's now run the code before
looking at those two functions let me do
make tree
dot slash tree and voila one two three
so it sounds like the data structure is
sorted to your concern earlier but how
did I actually print this and then
eventually free the whole thing well
let's look at the definition of first
print tree and this is where things get
kind of interesting print tree returns
uh nothing so it's a void function but
it takes a pointer to a root element as
its sole argument node star root here's
my safety check if root equals equals
null there's obviously nothing to print
just return that sort of goes without
saying but here's where things get a
little magical otherwise print your left
child
then print your own number
then print your right child
what is this an example of even though
it's not mentioned by name here
what programming technique here
so yeah so this is actually perhaps the
most compelling use of recursion yet it
wasn't really that compelling with the
Mario thing because we had such an easy
implementation with a for Loop weeks ago
but here is kind of a perfect
application of recursion where your data
structure itself is recursive right if
you take any snip of any branch it all
still looks like a tree just a smaller
one that lends itself to recursion so
here is this leap of faith where I say
ah print my left tree or my left sub
tree if you will via my child at the
left then I'll print my own root node
here in the middle then go ahead and
print my right subtree and because we
have this base case that just makes sure
that if the tree the root is null
there's nothing to do you're not going
to recurse infinitely you're not going
to call yourself again and again and
again infinitely many times so it just
kind of works out and prints the one the
two and the three and notice what we
could do too if you wanted to print the
tree in reverse order you could do that
print your right tree first the greater
element then yourself then then your
smaller subtree and if I do make tree
here in dot slash tree voila now I've
reversed the order of the list and
that's pretty cool you could do it with
a for Loop in an array but you can also
do it even with this two-dimensional
structure let's lastly look just at this
free tree function and this one's almost
the same order doesn't matter in quite
the same way but it does still matter
here's what I did with free tree well if
the root of the tree is an ALT there's
obviously nothing to do just return
otherwise go ahead and free your left
child and all of its descendants then
For Your Right child and all of its
descendants and then for yourself and
again free literally just freeze the
address in that variable doesn't free
the whole darn thing it just frees
literally what's at that address why was
it important that I did line 72 last
though
why did I free the left child and the
right child before I freed myself so to
speak
exactly if you free yourself first if I
had done incorrectly this line higher up
you're not allowed to touch the left
child subtree or the right child subtree
because the memory address is no longer
valid at that point you would get some
kind of memory error perhaps the program
would crash valgrin definitely wouldn't
like it bad things would otherwise
happen but here then is an example of
recursion and again just a recursive use
of an actual data structure and what's
even cooler here isn't relatively
speaking suppose we wanted to search
something like this binary search
actually gets pretty straightforward to
implement two for instance here might be
the prototype for a search function for
a binary search tree you give me the
address the root of a tree and you give
me a number I'm looking for and I can
pretty easily now return true if it's in
there or false if it's not how well
let's first ask a question if tree
equals equals null then you just return
false because if there's no tree there's
no number so it's obviously not there
return false else if the number you're
looking for is less than the tree's own
number
which direction should we go
okay left how do we express that well
let's just return the answer to this
question search the left subtree by way
of my left child looking for the same
number and you just assume through the
beauty of recursion you're kicking the
can and let yourself figure it out with
a smaller problem just that snipped left
tree instead else if the number you're
looking for is greater than the tree's
own number go to the right as you might
infer so I can just return the answer to
this question search my right subtree
for that same number
and there's a fourth and final condition
what's the fourth scenario we have to
consider explicitly yeah
if the number itself is right there so
else if the number I'm looking for
equals the tree's own number then and
only then should you return true and if
you're you're thinking quickly here
there's an optimization possible better
design opportunity
think back to even our scratch days what
could we do a little better here you're
pointing at it
exactly and else suffices because if
there's logically only four things that
could happen you're wasting your time by
asking a fourth gratuitous question and
else here suffices so here too more so
than the Mario example a few weeks ago
there's just this Elegance arguably to
recursion and that's it this is not
pseudocode this is the code for binary
cert on a binary search tree and so
recursion tends to work in lockstep with
these kinds of data structures that have
this kind of structure to them as we're
seeing here
are any questions then on
binary search
as implemented here with a tree yeah
[Music]
uh good question so when returning a
Boolean value true and false are values
that are defined in a library called
standard ghoul STD bool.h with the
header file that you can use it is the
case that true is
it's not well defined what they are but
they would map indeed yes to zero and
one essentially but you should not
compare them explicitly to zero and one
when you're using true and false you
should compare them to each other
[Music]
foreign
so if I am in my own code from earlier
in a void function it is totally fine to
return you just can't return something
explicitly so return just means that's
it quit out of this function you're not
actually handing back a value so it's a
way of short-circuiting the execution if
you don't like that and some people do
frown upon having code return from
functions prematurely you could invert
the logic and do something like this if
the root does not equal null do all of
these things and then indent all three
of these lines underneath that's
perfectly fine too I happen to write it
the other way just so that there was
explicitly a base case that I could
point to on the screen whereas now it's
kind of implicitly there for us only but
a good observation too all right so
let's ask the question as before about
like running time of this it would look
like binary search is back and we can
now do things in logarithmic time but we
should be careful is this a binary
search tree just to be clear
and again a binary search tree is a tree
where the root is greater than its left
child and smaller than its right child
that's the essence so you're Shake
you're nodding your head you agree
okay I agree so this is a binary search
tree
is this a binary search tree
okay I'm hearing yeses or I'm hearing
just my delay changing the vote it would
seem so this is kind of one of those
trick questions this is a binary search
tree because I've not violated the
definition of what I gave you right is
there any example of a left child that
is greater than its parent or is there
any example of a right child that's
smaller than its parent that's just the
opposite way of describing the same
thing no this is a binary search tree
unfortunately it also looks like albeit
at a different axis what
a linked list but you could imagine this
happening right suppose that I hadn't
been as thoughtful as I was earlier by
inserting two and then one and then
three which kind of nicely balanced
everything out suppose that instead
because of what the user is typing in or
whatever you can drive in your own code
suppose you insert a one and then a two
and then a three like you've kind of
created a problem for yourself because
if we follow the same logic as before
going left or going right this is how
you might Implement a binary search tree
accidentally if you just blindly keep
following that definition I mean this
would be better designed as what if we
kind of like rotated the whole thing
around and that's totally fine and those
kinds of trees actually have names
there's trees called AVL trees and
computer science there are red black
trees in computer science there are
other types of trees that additionally
add some logic that tell you when you
got to Pivot the thing and rotate it and
kind of snip off the root and fix things
in this way but a binary search tree in
and of itself does not guarantee that it
will be balanced so to speak and so if
you consider the worst case scenario of
even using a binary search tree if
you're not smart about the code you're
writing and you just blindly follow this
definition you might accidentally create
a crazy long and stringy binary search
tree that essentially looks like a
linked list because you're not even
using any of the left children so
unfortunately the literal answer to the
question here is what's the running time
of search well hopefully log in but not
if you don't maintain the balance of the
tree both insert in search could
actually devolve into instead of Big O
of login literally Big O of n if you
don't somehow take into account and
we're not going to do the code for that
here sort of a higher level thing you
might explore Beyond down the road it
can devolve into something that you
might not have intended and so now that
we're talking about two Dimensions it's
really the onus is on the programmer to
consider what kinds of perverse
situations might happen where the thing
devolves into a structure that you don't
actually want it to devolve into
all right we've got just a few
structures to go let's go ahead and take
one more five minute break here when we
come back we'll talk at this level about
some final applications of this see you
in five
all right
so we are back and as promised we'll
sort of operate now at this higher level
where if we take for granted that even
though we haven't had an opportunity to
play with these techniques yet you have
the ability now in code to kind of
stitch things together both in a Wonder
Dimension and even two Dimensions to
build things like lists and trees so if
we have these building blocks things
like now arrays and lists and trees what
if we start to kind of amalgamate them
such that we build things out of
multiple data structures can we start to
get some of the Best of Both Worlds by
way of for instance something called a
hash table so a hash table is sort of a
Swiss army knife of data structures in
that it's so commonly used because it
allows you to associate keys with value
so to speak so for instance it allows
you to associate a username with a
password or a name with a number or
anything where you have to take
something as input and get as output a
corresponding piece of information and
hash table is often a data structure of
choice and here's what it looks like
it's actually looks like an array at
first glance but for discussion's sake
I've drawn this array vertically which
is totally fine it's still just an array
but it allows you a hash table to jump
to any of these locations randomly that
is instantly so for instance there's
actually 26 locations in this array
because I want to for instance store
initially names of people for instance
and wouldn't it be nice if the person's
name starts with a I have a go-to place
for it maybe the first box and if it
starts with z i put them at the bottom
so that I can jump instantly
arithmetically using a little bit of
ASCII or Unicode fanciness exactly to
the location that they wanna they need
to go so for instance here's our array 0
index 0 through 25 if I think of this
though as a through z I'm going to think
of these 26 locations now in the context
of a hash table is what we'll generally
call buckets so buckets into which you
can put values so for instance suppose
that we want to insert a value one name
into this data structure and that name
is say Albus so Albus starting with a
Albus might be go at the very beginning
of this list all right and then we want
to insert another name this one happens
to be Zacharias starting with z so it
goes all the way at the end of this data
structure in location 25 AKA Z and then
maybe a third name like Hermione and
that goes at location H according to
that position in the alphabet so this is
great because in constant time I can
insert and conversely search for any of
these names based on the first letter of
their name a or Z or H in this case
let's fast forward and assume we put a
whole bunch of other names it might look
familiar into this hash table it's great
because every name has its own location
but if you're thinking of names you
don't yet see it on the screen we
eventually encounter a problem with this
right when could something go wrong
using a hash table like this if we
wanted to insert even more names
what's going to eventually happen
yeah there's already someone with the
first letter right like I haven't even
mentioned Harry for instance or Hagrid
and yet Hermione is already using that
spot so that sort of invites the
question well what happens maybe if we
want to insert Harry next do we maybe
cheat and put him at location I but then
if there's sudden location I where do we
put them and it just feels like the
situation could very quickly devolve but
I've deliberately drawn this data
structure that I claim is a hash table
sort of in two directions an array
vertically here
but what might this be hinting I'm using
horizontally even though I'm drawing the
rectangles a little differently from
before
yeah maybe another array to be fair but
honestly erasers to Japan with the
allocating and reallocating and so forth
these kind of look like the beginnings
of a linked list if you will where the
name is where the number used to be even
though I'm drawing it horizontally now
just for discussion sake and this seems
to be like a pointer that isn't pointing
anywhere yet but it looks like the array
is 26 pointers some of which are null
that is empty some of which are pointing
at the first node in a linked list so
that's really what a hash table might be
in your mind an amalgam of a an array
whose elements are linked lists and in
theory this kind of gives you the best
of both worlds right you get Random
Access with high probability right you
get to jump immediately to the location
you want to put someone but if you run
into this perverse situation where
there's someone already there okay fine
it starts to devolve into a linked list
but it's at least 26 smaller length
lists not one massive linked list which
would be Big O of N and quite slow to
solve so if Harry gets inserted in
Hagrid yeah you have to kind of chain
them together
so to speak in this way but at least
you're not you've not painted yourself
into a corner and in fact if we fast
forward and put a whole bunch of
familiar names in the data structure
starts to look like this so the chains
not terribly long and some of them are
actually of size zero because there's
just some unpopular letters of the
alphabet among these names but it seems
better than just putting everyone in one
big array or one big linked list we're
sort of trying to balance these
trade-offs a little bit in the middle
here well how might we represent
something like this here's how we could
describe this thing a node in the
context of a linked list could be this I
have an array called word of type Char
and it's big enough to fit the longest
word in the alphabet plus one and the
plus one y probably
the null character so I'm assuming that
longest word is like a constant defined
elsewhere in the story and it's
something big like 40 100 whatever
whatever the longest word in the uh
Harry Potter universe is or the English
alphabet or English dictionary is
longest word plus one should be
sufficient to store any name in the
story here and then what else does each
of these nodes have well it has a
pointer to another node so here's how we
might implement the notion of a node in
the context of storing not integers but
names instead like this but how do we
decide what the hash table itself is
well if we now have a definition of a
node we could have a variable in main or
even globally called hash table that
itself is an array
of node star
pointers that is an array of pointers to
nodes the beginnings of linked lists
number of buckets is kind of up to me I
proposed verbally that it'd be 26 but
honestly if you get a lot of collisions
so to speak a lot of H names trying to
go to the same place well maybe we need
to be smarter and not just look at the
first letter of their name but maybe the
first and the second so it's H A and H E
but wait no then Harry and Hagrid still
Collide but we start to at least make
the problem a little less impactful by
tinkering with something like the number
of buckets in a hash table like this but
how do we decide where someone goes in a
hash table in this way well it's an old
school problem of input and output the
input to the problem is going to be
something like the name and the
algorithm in the middle as of today is
going to be something called a hash
function a hash function is generally
something that takes as input a string a
number whatever and produces this output
a location in our context like a number
0 through 25 or 0 through 16 000 or
whatever the number of buckets you want
is it's going to just tell you where to
put that input at a specific location so
for instance Albus according to the
story thus far gave me back zero as
output Zacharias gave me 25. so the hash
function in the middle of that black box
is pretty simplistic in this story it's
just looking at like the ASCII value it
seems of the first letter in their name
and then subtracting off what capital A
is 65 so like doing some math to get
back a number between 0 and 25. so
that's how we got to this point in the
story and how might we then resolve the
problem further and use this notion of
hashing more generally well just for
demonstrations sake here here's actually
some buckets literally and we've labeled
and advanced these buckets with the
suits from a deck of cards so we've got
some Spades and we've got diamonds
here
and we've got what else here uh
clubs
and hearts
so we have a deck of cards here for
instance right and this is something you
yourself might do instinctively If
you're sort of getting ready to start
playing a game of cards you're just kind
of cleaning up or you want things in
order like here is literally a jumbo
deck of cards what would be the easiest
way for me to sort these things well
we've got a whole bunch of sorting
algorithms from the past so I could go
through like here's the three of
diamonds and I could here let me throw
this up on the screen just so if you're
far and back so here's uh you know
diamonds I could put this here three
four I could do this in order here but a
lot of us honestly if given a deck of
cards and you just want to kind of clean
it up and sort it in order you might do
things like this well here's my input
three of diamonds let's put it in this
bucket four of diamonds this bucket five
of diamonds this bucket and if you keep
going through the cards here's seven of
hearts hearts bucket eight bucket uh
Queen of Spades over here and it's still
going to take you 52 steps but at the
end of it you have hashed all of the
Cards into four distinct buckets and now
you have problems of size 13 10 which is
a little more tenable than doing one
massive 52 card problem you can now do
four 13 size problems and so hashing is
something that even you and I might do
instinctively taking as input some card
some name and producing his output some
location a sort of temporary Pile in
which you want to Stage things so to
speak
but these collisions are kind of
inevitable and honestly if we kept going
through the Harry Potter Universe some
of these chains would get longer and
longer and longer which means that
instead of getting someone's name
quickly by searching for them or
inserting them might start taking a
decent amount of time so what could we
do instead to resolve situations like
this if the problem fundamentally is
that the first letter is just too darn
popular H we need to take in more input
not just the first letter but maybe the
first two letters so if we do that we
can go from a through z to something
more extreme like maybe h a h b h c h d
h e h f and so forth so that now Harry
and Hermione end up at different
locations but you know darn it Hagrid
still collides with Harry so it's better
than before the chains aren't quite as
long but the problem isn't fundamentally
gone and in this case here
anyone know how many buckets we just
increased to if we now look at not just
a through z but a a through z z
roughly
yeah so okay good so these answer 26
squared or 676 so that's a lot more
buckets and this is why I only showed a
few of them on the screen so that's a
lot more and it spreads things out
specific uh in particular what if we
take this one step further instead of H
A we do like h a a h a b h a c h z and
so forth well now we have an even better
situation because Hermione has her one
spot Harry has his one spot Hagrid has
his one spot
but there's a trade-off here the upside
is now arithmetically we can find their
locations in constant time maybe
technically three steps but three is
constant no matter how many other names
are in here it would seem but what's the
downside here
sorry say again
memory so significantly more we're now
up to 17
576 buckets which itself isn't that big
a deal right computers have a lot of
memory these days but as you can kind of
infer you know I can't really think of
someone whose name started with heq for
instance in the Harry Potter universe
and if we keep going definitely don't
know of anyone whose name started with
zzz or AAA there's a lot of sort of not
useful combinations that have to be
there mathematically so that you can do
a bit of math and jump to randomly so to
speak the precise location but they're
just going to be empty so it's a very
sparsely populated array so to speak so
what does that really mean for
performance ultimately well let's
consider again in the context of our Big
O notation it turns out that a hash
table technically speaking is still just
going to give us Big O of n in the worst
case why if you have some crazy perverse
case where everyone in the universe has
a name that starts with a or starts with
H or starts with z you just get really
unlucky and your chain is massively long
well then at that point it's just a
linked list it's not a hash table it's
like the perverse situation with the
tree where if you insert it without any
mind for balancing it keeping it
balanced it just evolves but there's a
difference here between sort of a
theoretical performance and an actual
performance if you look back at the tree
the hash table here this is absolutely
in practice going to be faster than a
single linked list you know
mathematically asymptotically Big O
notation sure it's all the same Big O of
n but if what we're really caring about
is real humans using our software
there's something to be said for
crafting a data structure that
technically if this data were uniformly
distributed is 26 times faster than a
linked list alone and so there's this
tension two in between like systems
types of Cs and theoretical CS where
yeah theoretically these are all the
same but in practice we're making real
world software you know improving this
speed by a factor of 26 in this case let
alone 576 or more might actually make a
big difference but there's going to be a
trade-off and that's typically some
other resource like giving up more space
all right how about another data
structure we could build let me fast
forward to something here called a try
so a try sort of a weird name and
pronunciation short for retrieval
pronounced try typically a try is a tree
that actually gives us constant time
look up even for massive
data sets what do I mean by this in the
world of a try you create a tree out of
arrays so we're really getting into like
the Frankenstein territory of just
building things up with like spare parts
of data structures that we have here but
the root of a try is itself an array for
instance of size 26 where each element
in that try points to another node which
is to say another array and each of
those locations in the array represents
a letter of the alphabet Like A through
Z so for instance if you wanted to store
the names of the Harry Potter Universe
not in a hash table not in a linked list
not in a tree but in a try what you
would do is hash
on every letter in the person's name one
at a time so a try is like a multi-tier
hash table in a sense where you first
look at the first letter then the second
letter then the third and you do the
following for instance each of these
locations represents a letter A through
Z suppose I wanted to insert someone's
name into this that starts with the
letter A H like Hagrid for instance well
I go to the location h i see it's null
which means I need to malloc myself
another node or another array and that's
depicted here then suppose I want to
store the second letter in Hagrid's name
in a so I go to that location in the
second node and I see okay it's
currently null there's nothing below it
so I allocate another node using malloc
or the like and now I have h a g and I
continue this with r i d and then when I
get to the bottom of this person's name
I just have to indicate here in color
but probably with a Boolean value or
something like a true value that says a
name stops here so that it's clear that
the person's name is not h a h a or h a
g or h-a-r or hagr it's
h-a-g-r-i-d and the D is green just to
indicate there's like some other Boolean
value that just says yes this is the
node in which the name stops and if I
continue this logic here's how I might
insert someone like Harry
and here's how I might insert someone
like Hermione and what's interesting
about the design here is that some of
these names share a common prefix which
starts to get compelling because you're
reusing space you're using the same
nodes for names like h a g and h-a-r
because they share H in an A in common
and they all share an H in common
so you have this data structure now that
itself is a tree each node in the tree
is itself an array and we therefore
might implement this thing using Code
like this every node is containing
I'll do it in reverse order a an array
I'll call it children because that's
what it really represents up to 26
children for each of these nodes size of
the alphabet so I might have used a
constant for number 26 to give myself 26
letters of the alphabet and each of
those arrays stores that many node stars
that many pointers to another node and
here's an example of the bull this is
what I represented in green on the slide
a moment ago I also need another piece
of data just a zero or One A true or
false that says yes a name stops in this
node or it's just a path to the rest of
the person's name but the upside of this
is that the height of this tree is only
as tall as the person's longest name
h-a-g-r-i-d or
h-e-r-m-i-o-n-e and notice that no
matter how many other people are in this
data structure there's three at the
moment if there were three million it
would still take me how many steps to
search for Hermione
h-e-r-m-i-o-n-e so eight steps total no
matter if there's two other people two
million 10 million other people because
the path to her name is always on the
same path and if you assume that there's
uh there's a maximum limit on the length
of names in the human world maybe it's
40 100 whatever whatever the longest
name in the world is that's constant
maybe it's 40 100 but that's constant
which is to say that with a try
technically speaking it is the case that
your look up time Big O of n a Big O
notation would be Big O of one it's
constant time because unlike every other
data structure we've looked at with a
try the Run amount of time it takes you
to find one person or insert one person
is completely independent of how many
other pieces of data are already in the
data structure and this holds true even
if one name is a prefix of another I
don't think there was a a Daniel or
Danielle in the Harry Potter universe
that I could think of but
d-a-n-i-e-l could be one name and
therefore we have a true there in green
and if there's a longer name like
Danielle then you keep going until you
get to the E so you can still have with
a try one name that's a substring of
another name so it's not as though we've
created a problem there that too is
still possible
but at the end of the day it only takes
a finite number of steps to find any of
these people and again that's what's
particularly compelling that you
effectively have constant time look up
so that's amazing right we've gone
through this whole story for weeks now
of like linear time and then it went up
to like N squared and then log in and
now constant time what's the price paid
for a data structure like this
this so-called try
what's the downside here there's got to
be a catch
and in fact tries are not actually used
that often amazing as they might sound
on some CS level here
memory what why in what sense
exactly if you're storing all of these
darn arrays it's again a sparse sparsely
populated data structure and you can
kind of see it here granted there's only
three names but most of those boxes most
of those pointers are going to remain
null so this is an incredibly wide data
structure if you will it uses a huge
amount of memory to store the names but
again you got to pick a lane either
you're going to minimize space or you're
going to minimize time it's not really
possible to get truly The Best of Both
Worlds you have to decide where the
inflection point is for the device
you're writing software for how much
memory it has how much expensive it is
and again taking all of these kinds of
things into an account
so lastly let's do one further
abstraction so even higher level to
discuss something that are generally
known as abstract data structures it
turns out we could spend like all day
all week talking about different things
we could build with these data
structures but for the most part now
that we have arrays now that we have
linked lists or their cousins trees
which are two-dimensional and beyond
that there's even graphs where the
arrows can go in multiple directions not
just down so to speak now that we have
this ability to Stitch things together
we can solve all different types of
problems so for instance a very common
type of data structure to use in a
program or even our human world are
things called cues a q being a data
structure like a line outside of a store
where it has what's called a fifo
property first in first out which is
great for fairness at least in the human
world and if you've ever waited outside
of uh tasty burger or Salsa Fresca or
some other restaurant nearby presumably
if you're queuing up at the counter you
want them store to maintain a fifo
system first and first down so that
whoever's first in line and gets their
food first and gets out first so a fight
a cue is actually a computer science
term too and even if you're still in the
habit of printing things on paper there
are things you might have heard called
printer cues which also do things in
order the first person to send their
essay to the printer should ideally be
printed before the last person to send
their essay to the printer again in the
interest of fairness but how can you
implement a queue well you typically
have to implement like two fundamental
operations NQ and DQ so adding something
to it and removing something from it and
the interesting thing here is that how
do you implement a queue well in the
human world you would just have like
literally physical space for humans to
line up from left to right or right to
left same in a computer like a printer
queue if you send a whole bunch of jobs
to be printed a whole bunch of essays or
documents well you need a chunk of
memory like an array all right well if
you use an array what's a problem that
could happen in the World of Printing
for instance if you use an array to
store all of the documents that need to
be printed
it could be filled right so if the
programmer decided HP or whoever makes
the printer decides oh you can send like
a megabyte worth of documents to this
printer at once at some point you might
get an error message which says sorry
out of memory wait a few minutes which
is maybe a reasonable solution but a
little Annoying or HP could write code
that maybe dynamically resizes the array
or so forth but at that point maybe they
should just use a linked list and they
could so there too you could implement
the notion of a queue
using a linked list instead you're going
to spend more memory but you're not
going to run out of space in your array
which might be more compelling you know
this happens even in the physical world
you go to the store and you know you
start having to line up outside and down
the road and like for a really busy
store they kind of run out of space so
they they make do but in that case it
tends to be more of an array just
because of the physical notion of humans
lining up but there's other data
structures too if you've ever gone to
the dining hall and picked up like a
Harvard or Yale tray right you're
typically picking up the last tray that
was just cleaned not the first tray that
was cleaned why because these uh
cafeteria trays stack up on top of each
other and indeed a stack is another type
of abstract data structure in the
physical world it's literally something
physical like a stack of trays which
have what we would call a lifo property
last in first out so as these things
come out of the washer they're putting
the most recent ones on the top and then
you the human are probably taking the
most recently cleaned one which means in
the extreme the no one on campus might
ever use that very first tray which is
probably fine in the world of trays but
would really be bad in the world of like
tasty burger lining up for food if lifo
were the property being implemented but
here too it could be an array it could
be a linked list and you see this
honestly every day if you're using Gmail
and your Gmail inbox that is actually
kind of a stack at least by default
where your newest message last in are
the first ones at the top of the screen
that's kind of a lifo data structure and
it means that you see your most recent
emails but if you have a busy day you're
getting a lot of emails it might not be
a good thing because now you're kind of
ignoring the people who wrote you way
earlier in the day or the week so lifo
and fifo are just properties that you
can achieve with these very specific
types of data structures and the
parlance in the world of stacks is to
push something onto a stack or pop
something out these are here for
instance is an example of like why might
you always wear the same color well if
you're storing all of your clothes in a
stack you might not ever get to like the
different colored clothes at the bottom
of the list and in fact to paint this
picture we have a a couple minute uh
video here just to to paint this here
made by a faculty member elsewhere let's
go ahead and dim the lights for just a
minute or two here so that we can take a
look at Jack learning some facts
once upon a time there was a guy named
Jack when it came to making friends Jack
did not have the Knack so Jack went to
talk to the most popular guy he knew he
went up the loo and asked what do I do
Lou saw that his friend was really
distressed well it began just look how
you're dressed don't you have any
clothes with a different look yes said
Jack I sure do come to my house and I'll
show them to you so they went off the
Jacks and Jack showed Lou the box where
he kept all his shirts and his pants and
his socks loose said I see you have all
your clothes in a pile why don't you
wear some others once in a while Jack
said well would I remove clothes and
socks I washed them and put them away in
the box then comes the next morning and
up I hop I go to the box and get my
clothes off the top Lou quickly realized
the problem with Jack he kept clothes
CDs and books in a stack when he reached
for something to read or to wear he
chose the top book or underwear then
when he was done he would put it right
back back it would go on top of the
stack I know the solution said a Triumph
at Lou you need to learn to start using
a cue Lou took Jack's clothes and hung
them in a closet and when he had emptied
the box he just tossed it then he said
now Jack at the end of the day put your
clothes and a left when you put them
away then tomorrow morning when you see
the sun shine get your clothes from the
right from the end of the line don't you
see said Lou it will be so nice you'll
wear everything once before you wear
something twice and with everything in
queues in his closet and shelf Jack
started to feel quite sure of himself
all thanks to Lou and his wonderful cue
foreign
that these things are everywhere
in the world even in our human world if
you've ever lined up at this place
anyone recognize this
okay so sweet green a little salad place
in the Square this is if you order
online or in advance your food ends up
according to the first letter in your
name which actually sounds awfully
reminiscent of something like a hash
table and in fact no matter whether you
implement a hash table like we did with
an array and linked lists or with like
three shelves like this this is actually
an abstract data type called a
dictionary in a dictionary just like in
our human world has keys and values
words and their definitions this just
has uh letters of the alphabet in salads
as their value but here too there's a
real world constraint at what in what
kind of scenario does this system at
sweetgreen devolve into a problem for
instance because they too are using only
finite space finite storage what could
go wrong yeah
yeah if they run out of space on the
shelf and there's a lot of people whose
name start with D or e or whatever and
so they just pile up and then maybe they
kind of overflow into the E's or the F's
and you know they probably don't really
care because any human is going to come
by and just eyeball and figure it out
anyway but in the world of a computer
you're the one coding and have to be
ever so precise we thought we would
lastly do one final thing here
um in advance we prepared a a linked
list of sorts in the audience since this
has become a bit of a thing I am
starting to represent the beginning of
this linked list and so far as I have a
pointer here with seat location G9 uh
whoever's in G9 would you mind standing
up
and what letter is on your sheet there
okay so you have S15 and your letter
say again F 15. so I see you're holding
a c in your node you are pointing to if
you could physically F15 F15 what do you
held
you have an S and who should you be
pointing at
F5 could you stand up F5 you're holding
a five I see what no what address
F12 big finale F12 if you'd like to
stand up holding a zero and null which
means that was cs50
all right we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
and this is already week six and this is
the week in which you learn yet another
language but the goal is not just to
teach you another language for
language's sake as we transition today
and in the coming weeks from C where we
spent the past several weeks now to
python the goal ultimately is to teach
you all how to teach yourselves new
languages so that by the end of this
course it's not in your mind the fact
that you learned how to program in C or
learned some we expect how to program in
scratch but really how you learned how
to program fundamentally in a paradigm
known as procedural programming as well
as with some taste today and in the
weeks to come of other aspects of
programming languages like object
oriented programming and more so recall
though back in week zero hello worlds
looked a little something like this and
the world was quite simple all you had
to do was drag and drop these puzzle
pieces but there were still functions
and conditionals and loops and variables
and all of those kinds of Primitives we
then transitioned of course to a much
more Arcane language that looked to
little something like this and even now
some weeks later you might still be
struggling with some of the syntax or
getting annoying bugs when you try to
compile your code and it just doesn't
work but there too the past few weeks
we've been focusing on functions and
loops and variables conditionals and
really all of those same ideas and so
what we begin to do today is to one
simplify the language we're using
transitioning from C now to python this
now being the equivalent program in
Python and look at its relative
Simplicity but also transitioning to
look at how you can Implement these same
kinds of features just using a different
language so we're going to see a lot of
code today and you won't have nearly as
much practice with python as you did
with C but that's because so many of the
ideas are still going to be with us and
really it's going to be a process of
figuring out all right I want to do a
loop I know how to do it and see how do
I do this in Python how do I do the same
with conditionals how do I declare
variables and the like and moving
forward not just in cs50 but in life in
general if you continue programming and
learn some other language after the
class if in five ten years there's a new
more popular language that you pick up
it's just going to be a matter of
Googling and looking at websites like
stack Overflow and the like to look at
just basic building blocks of
programming languages because you
already speak after these past six plus
weeks you already speak programming
itself fundamentally all right so let's
do a few quick comparisons left and
right of what something might have
looked like in scratch and what it then
looked like in C but now as of today
what it's going to look like in Python
then we'll turn our attention to the
command line ultimately in order to
implement some actual programs so in
scratch we had functions like this say
hello world a verb or an action in C it
looked a little something like this and
a bit of a cryptic mess the first week
you had the printf you had the double
quotes you had the semicolon the
parentheses there's a lot more syntax
just to do the same thing we're not
going to get rid of all of that syntax
now but as of today in Python that same
statement is going to look a little
something like this and just to perhaps
call out the obvious what is different
or now simpler in python versus C even
in this simple example here yeah
good so it's now print instead of printf
and there's also no semicolon and
there's one other subtlety over here
yeah so no new line and that doesn't
mean it's not going to be printed it
just turns out that one of the
differences we'll see is that with print
you get the new line for free it
automatically gets outputted by default
being sort of a common case but you can
override it we'll see ultimately too how
about in scratch we had multiple
functions like this that not only said
something on the screen but also asked a
question thereby being another function
that returned a value called answer in C
we saw code that looked a little
something like this whereby that first
line declares a variable called answer
sets it equal to the return value of get
string one of the functions from the
cs50 library and then the same double
quotes and parentheses and semicolon
then we had this format code in C that
allowed us with percent s to actually
print out that same value in Python this
too is going to look a little bit
simpler instead we're going to have
answer equals get string quote unquote
what's your name and then print with a
plus sign and a little bit of new syntax
but let's see if we can't just infer
from this example what it is that's
going on well first missing on the left
is what
to the left of the equal sign there's no
what this time
feel free to just call it out
so there's no type there's no type like
the word string which even though that
was a type in cs50 every other variable
in C did we use int or string or float
or bull or something else in Python
there's still going to be data types
today onward but you the programmer
don't have to bother telling the
computer what types you're using the
computer is going to be smart enough the
language really is going to be smart
enough to just figure it out from
Context meanwhile on the right hand side
get string is going to be a function
we'll use today in this week which comes
from a python version of the cs50
library but will also start to take off
those training wheels so that you'll see
how to do things without any cs50
Library moving forward using a different
function instead as before no semicolon
but the rest of the syntax is pretty
much the same here this starts of course
to get a little bit different though
we're using print instead of printf but
now even though this looks a little
cryptic perhaps if you've never
programmed before cs50 what might that
plus be doing
just based on inference here what do you
think
[Music]
yeah so adding answer to the string
hello and adding so to speak not
mathematically but in the form of
joining them together much like we saw
the join Block in scratch or
concatenation was the term of art there
this plus sign appends if you will
whatever is in answer to whatever is
quoted here and I deliberately left a
space there so that grammatically it
looks nice after the comma as well now
there's another way to do this and it
too is going to look cryptic at first
glance but it just gets easier and more
convenient over time you can also change
this second line to be this instead
so what's going on here this is actually
a relatively new feature of python in
the past couple of years where now what
you're seeing is yes a string between
these same double quotes but this is
what python would call a format string
or F string and it literally starts with
the letter F which admittedly looks I
think a little weird but that just
indicates that python should ensue
assume that anything inside of curly
braces inside of the string should be
interpolated so to speak which is a
fancy term saying substitute the value
of any variables therein and it can do
some other things as well so answer is a
variable declared of course on this
first line this F string then says to
python print out hello comma space and
then the value of answer if by contrast
you avoid if you omitted the curly
braces just take a guess what would
happen What would the symptom of that
bug be if you accidentally forgot the
curly braces but maybe still had the F
there
yeah I would literally print hello comma
answer because it's going to take you
literally so the curly braces just kind
of allow you to plug things in and again
it looks a little more cryptic but it's
just going to save us time over time and
if any of you programmed in Java in high
school for instance you saw Plus in that
context too for concatenation this just
kind of makes your code a little tighter
a little more succinct so it's a
convenient feature now in Python all
right this was an example in scratch of
a variable setting a variable like
counter equal to zero in C it looked
like this where you specify the type the
name and then the value with a semicolon
in Python it's going to look like this
and I'll State the obvious here you
don't need to mention the type just like
before with string and you don't need a
semicolon so it's a little simpler if
you want a variable just write it and
set it equal to some value but the
single equal sign still behaves the same
as in C suppose we wanted to increment
counter by one in scratch we use this
puzzle piece here in C we could do this
actually in a few different ways there
was this way if counter already exists
you just say counter equals counter plus
one there was the slightly less verbose
way where you could whoops sorry in let
me do the first sentence first in Python
that same thing as you might guess is
actually going to be almost the same you
just throw away the semicolon and the
mathematics are ultimately the same
copying from right to left via the
assignment operator now recall and see
that we had this shorthand notation
which did the same thing in Python you
can similarly do the same thing just no
need for the semicolon the only step
backwards we're taking if you were a big
fan of counter plus plus that doesn't
exist in Python nor minus minus you just
can't do it you have to do the plus
equals one or plus minus or minus equals
one to achieve that same result all
right how about in Python 2 here in
scratch recall was a conditional asking
a silly question like is X less than y
and if so just say as much in C that
looked a little something like this
printf and if with the parentheses the
curly braces the semicolon and all of
that in Python this is going to get a
little more pleasant to type two it's
going to be just the this
and if someone wants to call it some of
the obvious changes here what has been
simplified now in Python for a
conditional it would seem
yeah what's missing or chain
so no curly braces
and sorry
and we're using the colon instead so I
got rid of the curly braces in Python
but I'm using a colon instead and even
though this is a single line of code so
long as you indent subsequent lines
along with the printf that's going to
imply that everything if the if
condition is true should be executed
below it until you start to unindent and
start writing a different line of code
altogether so indentation in Python is
important so this is among the reasons
we've emphasized uh axes like Style just
how well styled your code is and
honestly we've seen certainly in office
hours and you're seen in your own code
sort of a tendency sometimes to be a
little LAX when it comes to indentation
right if you're one of those folks who
likes to indent everything on the left
hand side of the window yeah it might
compile and run but it's not
particularly readable by you or anyone
else python actually addresses this by
just requiring indentation when
logically needed so python is going to
force you to start indenting properly
now if that's been perhaps a tendency
otherwise what else is missing well we
have no semicolon here of course it's
print instead of printf but otherwise
those seem to be the primary differences
what about something larger in scratch
if an if else block like this you can
perhaps guess what it's going to look
like and see it looked like this curly
braces semicolons and so forth in Python
it's going to now look like this almost
the same but indentation is important
the colons are important and there's one
other difference that's now again
visible here but we didn't call it out a
second ago what else is different in
python versus C for these conditionals
yeah
perfect we don't have any parentheses
around the condition the Boolean
expression itself and why not well it's
just simpler to type it's less to type
you can still use parentheses and in
fact you might want to or need to if you
want to like uh combine thoughts and do
this and that or this or that but by
default you no longer need or should
have those parentheses just say what you
mean lastly with conditionals we had
something like this and if else if else
statement in C it looked a little
something like this in Python it's going
to get really tighter now it's just if
and this is the Curiosity L if x greater
than y so it's not else if it's
literally one keyword L if and the
colons remain now on each of the three
lines but the indentation is important
and if we did want to do multiple things
we could just indent below each of these
conditionals as well all right let me
pause theirs first to see if there's any
questions on the syntactic differences
yeah
all right
[Music]
uh in between it's between what and what
ah good question is Python's uh
sensitive to spaces and where they go
sometimes no sometimes yes is the short
answer stylistically though you should
be practicing what we're preaching here
whereby you do have spaces to the left
and right of binary operators that
they're called something like less than
or greater than is a binary operator
because there's two operands to the left
and to the right of them and in fact in
Python more so than the world of C
there's actually formal style
conventions not only within cs50 have we
had style a style guide on the courses
website for instance that just dictates
how you should write your code so that
it looks like everyone else is in the
python Community they take this one step
further and there's an actual standard
whereby you don't have to adhere to it
but generally speaking in the real world
someone would reprimand you would reject
your code if you're trying to contribute
it to another project if you don't hear
to these standards so while you could be
lacks with some of this white space do
make things readable and that's Python's
theme for the code to be as readable as
possible all right so let's take a look
at a couple of other cons structs before
transitioning to some actual code this
of course in scratch was a loop meowing
forever and see the closest we could get
was doing something while true because
true never changes so it's sort of a
simple way of just saying do this
forever in Python it's pretty much the
same thing but a couple small
differences here the parentheses are
gone the colon is there the indentation
is there no semicolon and there's one
other subtle difference what do you see
true is capitalized just because both
true and false are Boolean values in
Python but you got to start capitalizing
them just because all right how about a
loop like this where you repeat
something a finite number of times like
meowing three times in C we could do
this a few different ways there's this
very mechanical way where you initialize
a variable like I to zero you then use a
while loop and check if I is less than
three the total number of times you want
to meow then you print what you want to
print you increment ah using this syntax
or the longer more verbose syntax with
plus equals or whatnot and then you do
it again and again and again in Python
you can do it functionally the same way
same idea slightly different syntax you
just don't bother saying what type of
variable you want python will infer from
the fact that there's a zero right there
you don't need the parentheses you do
need the colon you do need the
indentation you can't do the I plus plus
but you can do this other technique as
we could have done in C as well how else
might we do this though too well it
turns out in C we could do something
like this which again and sort of
cryptic in at first glance became
perhaps more familiar where you have
initialization a conditional and then an
update that you do after each iteration
in Python there isn't really an analog
there is no analog in Python where you
have the parentheses and the multiple
semicolons in the same line instead
there is a for Loop but it's meant to
read a little more like English for I in
0 1 and 2. so we'll see in a bit these
square brackets represent an array now
to be called a list in Python so lists
in Python are more like linked lists
than they are in Array they are arrays
more on that soon so this just means for
I in the following list of three values
and on each iteration of this Loop
python automatically for you it first
sets I to zero then it sets I to one
then it sets I to two so that you
effectively do things three times
but this doesn't necessarily scale as
I've drawn it on the board suppose you
took this at face value as the way you
iterate some number of times in Python
using a for loop at what point does this
approach perhaps get bad or bad design
let me give folks just a moment to think
yeah I'm back
[Music]
sure if you don't know how many times
you want to Loop or iterate you can't
really create a hard-coded list like
that of zero one two other thoughts
where you wanted
[Music]
yeah if you're iterating a large number
of times this list is going to get
longer and longer and you're just kind
of stupidly going to be typing out like
comma 3 comma four comma five comma dot
dot comma 99 comma 100 I mean your code
would start to look atrocious eventually
so there is a better way in Python there
is a function or technically a type
called range that essentially magically
gives you back a range of values from
zero on up two but not through a value
so the effect of this line of code for I
in the following range essentially hands
you back a list of three values thereby
letting you do something three times and
if you want to do something 99 times
instead you of course just change the
three to a 99 question
is there a way to start to start getting
points at that range
or an integer that's higher than zero or
is there never really
a really good question can you start
counting at a higher number so not zero
which is the implied default but
something larger than that yes so it
turns out the range function takes
multiple arguments not just one but
maybe two or even three that allows you
to customize this Behavior so you can
customize where it begins you can
customize the increment by default it's
one but if you want to do every two
values for like evens or odds you could
do that as well and a few other things
and before long we'll take a look at
some python documentation that will
become your authoritative source for
answers like that like what can this
function do other questions on this thus
far
seeing none so what else might we uh
compare and contrast here well in the
world of C recall that we had a whole
bunch of built-in data types like these
here
um Bull and Char and double and float
and so forth string which happened to
come from the cs50 library but uh the
the language C itself certainly
understood the idea of strings because
the backslash zero the support for
percent s and printf that's all Native
built into c not a cs50 simplification
all we did and revealed as of a couple
of weeks ago is that string this data
type is just a synonym for a type def
for Char star which is part of the
language natively in Python now this
list actually gets a little shorter at
least for these common primitive data
types still going to have Bulls we're
gonna have floats and ins and we're
going to have strings but we're going to
call them stirs and this is not a cs50
thing from the library stir Str is in
fact a data type in Python that's going
to do a lot more than strings did for us
automatically in C ins and floats
meanwhile do don't need the
corresponding Longs and doubles because
in fact among the problems python solves
for us too ins can get as big as you
want integer overflow is no longer going
to be an issue per week one the language
solves that for us floating point and
precision unfortunately is still a
problem that remains but there are
libraries code that other people have
written as we briefly discussed in weeks
past that allow you to do scientific or
financial Computing using libraries that
build on top of these data types as well
so there's other data types too in
Python which we'll see actually gives us
a whole bunch of more power and
capability things called ranges like we
just saw lists like I called out
verbally with the square brackets things
called tuples for things like X comma y
or latitude comma longitude dictionaries
or dicks which allow you to store keys
and values much like our hash tables
from last time and then sets in the
mathematical sense where they filter out
duplicates for you and you can just put
a whole bunch of numbers a whole bunch
of words or whatnot and the language
with via this data type will filter out
duplicate kits for you now there's going
to be a few functions we give you this
week and Beyond training wheels that
we're then going to very quickly take
off just because as we'll see today they
just simplify the process of getting
user input correctly without
accidentally writing buggy code just
when you're trying to get hello world or
something similar to work and will give
you functions not like not as long as
this list in C but a subset of these get
float get int and get string that'll
automate the process of getting user
input in a way that's more resilient
against potential bugs but we'll see
what those bugs might be and the way
we're going to do this is similar in
spirit to see instead of doing include
cs50.h like we did in C you're going to
now start saying import cs50 python
supports similar to C libraries but
there aren't header files anymore you
just use the name of the library in
Python and if you want to import cs50s
functions you just say import cs50 or if
you want to be more precise and not just
import the whole thing which could be
slow if you've got a really big library
with a lot of of functionality in it you
can be more precise and say from cs50
import get flow from cs50 import get int
from cs50 import get string or you can
just separate them by commas and import
three and only three things from a
particular Library like ours but
starting today and onward we're going to
start making much more heavy use of
libraries code that other people wrote
so that we're no longer Reinventing the
wheel we're not making our own linked
lists our own trees our own dictionaries
we're going to start standing on the
shoulders of others so that you can get
real work done so to speak Faster by
building your software on top of others
code as well
all right so that's it for the syntactic
tour of the language and the sort of
core feature soon we'll transition to
application thereof but let me pause
here to see if there's any questions on
syntax or Primitives
or otherwise
oh yes and back
[Music]
oh sorry say it again why doesn't python
have what kind of operators
[Music]
sorry someone called when you said
something operators
[Music]
the oh the increment operator I'd have
to check the history honestly python has
tended to be a fairly minimalist
language and if you can do something one
way the community arguably has tended to
not give you multiple ways to do the
same thing syntactically
um there's probably a better answer and
I'll see if I can dig in and post
something online uh to follow up on that
all right so before we transition to now
writing some actual code let me go ahead
and consider exactly how we're going to
write code in the world of C recall that
it's generally been a two-step process
we create a file called like hello.c and
then step one make hello step two dot
slash hello or if you think back to week
two when we sort of peeled back the
layer of what hello what make was doing
you could more verbosely type out the
name of the actual compiler clang in our
case command line arguments like Dash o
hello to specify what name you want to
create and then you can specify the file
name and then you can specify what
libraries you want to link in so that
was a very verbose approach but it was
always a two-step approach and so even
as you've been doing recent problem sets
odds are you've realized that anytime
you want to make a change to your code
or make a change to your code and try
and test your code again you're
constantly doing those two steps moving
forward in Python it's going to become
simpler and it's going to be just this
the file name is going to change but
that might go without saying it's going
to be something like Hello dot Pi py
instead of hello.c and that's just a
convention using a different file
extension but there's no compilation
step per se you jump right to the
execution of your code and so python it
turns out is the name not only of the
language we're going to start using it's
also the name of a program on a Mac a PC
assuming it's been pre-installed that
interprets the language for you this is
to say that python is generally
described as being interpreted not
compiled and by that that I mean you get
to skip from the programmer's
perspective that compilation step there
is no manual step in the world of python
typically of writing your code and then
compiling it to zeros and ones and then
running the zeros and ones instead these
kind of two steps get collapsed into the
illusion of one whereby you instead are
able to just run the code and let the
computer figure out how to actually
convert it to something the computer
understands and the way we do that is
via this whole process input and output
but now when you have source code it's
going to be passed into an interpreter
not a compiler and the best analog of
this is just to perhaps point out that
in the human world if you speak or don't
speak multiple human languages it can be
a pretty slow process from going from
one language to another for instance
here are step-by-step instructions for
finding someone in a phone book
unfortunately in Spanish unfortunately
if you don't speak or read Spanish you
could figure this out you could run this
algorithm but you're going to have to do
some Googling or you're going to have to
open up literal dictionary from Spanish
to English and convert this and the
catch with translating any language
human or computer or otherwise is that
you're going to pay a price typically
some time and so converting this in
Spanish to this in English is just going
to take you longer than if this were
already in your native language and
that's going to be one of the subtleties
with the world of python yes it's a
feature that you can just run the code
without having to bother compiling it
manually first but we might pay a price
and things might be a little slower now
there's ways to chip away at that but
we'll see an example thereof in fact let
me transition now to just a couple of
examples that demonstrate how python is
not only easier for many people to use
perhaps yourselves too because it throws
away a lot of the Annoying syntax it
shortens the number of lines you have to
write and also it comes with so many
darn libraries you can just do so much
more without having to write the code
yourself so as an example of this let me
switch over here to this image from
problem set four which is the weeks
Bridge down by the Charles River here in
Cambridge and this is the original photo
pretty clear and it's even higher res if
we looked at the original version of the
photo but there have been no filters all
our Instagram applied to this photo
recall for problem set four you had to
implement a few filters and among them
might have been blur and blur was
probably among the more challenging of
the ones because you had to iterate over
all of the pixels you had to take into
account what's above what's below to the
left to the right I mean there's a lot
of math and arithmetic and if you
ultimately got it it was probably a
great sense of satisfaction but that was
probably several hours later in a
language like python where there might
be Library libraries that have been
written by others on Whose shoulders you
can stand we could perhaps do something
like this let me go ahead and run a
program or write a program called blur
dot Pi here and in blur dot Pi in vs
code let me just do this let me import
from a library not the cs50 library but
the pillow Library so to speak a keyword
called image and another one called
image filter then let me go ahead and
say let me open the current version of
this image which is called bridge.bmp so
the before version of the image will be
the result of calling image dot open
quote unquote bridge.bmp
and then let me create an after version
so you'll see before and after after
equals the before version dot filter of
image filter and there is if I read the
documentation I'll see that there's
something called a box blur that allows
you to blur in box format like one pixel
above below left and right so I'll do
one pixel there and then after that's
done let me go ahead and save the file
as something like out dot BMP
that's it assuming this Library works as
described I am opening the file in
Python using line three and this is
somewhat new syntax in the world of
python we're going to start making use
of the dot operator more because in the
world of python you have what's called
object oriented programming or oop as a
term of Art and what this means is that
you still have functions you still have
variables but sometimes those functions
are embedded inside of the variables or
more specifically inside of the data
types themselves think back to C when
you wanted to convert something to
uppercase there was a two upper function
that takes as input in argument that's a
Char and you can pass in any Char you
want and it will upper case it for you
and give you back a value well you know
what if that's such a common Paradigm
where uppercasing charge is a useful
thing what the world of python does is
it embeds into the string data type or
Char if you will the ability just to
uppercase any Char by treating the Char
or the string as though it's a struct in
C recall that strucks encapsulate
multiple types of values in
object-oriented programming in a
language like python you can encapsulate
not just values but also functionality
functions can now be inside of structs
but we're not going to call them structs
anymore we're going to call them objects
but that's just a different vernacular
so what am I doing here inside of the
image Library there's a function called
open and it takes an argument the name
of the file to open once I have a
variable called before that is a struct
or technically an object inside of which
is now because it was returned from this
function a function called filter that
takes an argument the argument here
happens to be image dot box blur one
which itself is a function but it just
Returns the filter to use and then
after.save does what you might think it
just saves the file so instead of using
F open and F right you just say dot save
and that does all of that messy work for
you so it's just what four lines of code
total let me go ahead and go down to my
terminal window let me go ahead and show
you with ls that at the moment whoops
sorry let me not bother showing that
because I have other examples to come
I'm going to go ahead and do python of
blur dot pi
nope sorry wrong place I did need to
make a command there we go okay let me
go ahead and type LS inside of my filter
directory which is among the sample code
online today there's only one file
called bridge.b damn it I'm trying to
get these things ready at the same time
let me rewind let me move this code into
place
all right I've gone ahead and moved this
file blur dot Pi into a folder called
filter inside of which there's another
file called bridge.bmp which we can
confer with ls let me now go ahead and
run python which is my interpreter and
also the name of the language and run
python on this file so much like running
the Spanish algorithm through Google
translate or something like that as
input to get back the English output
this is going to translate the Python
language to something this computer or
this cloud-based environment understands
and then run the corresponding code top
to bottom left to right I'm going to go
ahead and enter no error message is
generally a good thing if I type LS
you'll now see out.bmp let me go ahead
and open that and you know what just to
make clear what's really happening let
me blur it even further let's make a box
that's not just one pixel around but 10
so let's make that change and let me
just go ahead and rerun it with python
of blurred up high I still have out.bmp
let me go ahead and open out.bmp and
show you first the before
which looks like this that's the
original and now crossing my fingers
four lines of code later
the result of blurring it as well so the
library is doing all of the same kind of
leg work that you all did for the
assignment but it's encapsulated it all
into a single library that you can then
use instead those of you who might have
been feeling more comfortable might have
done a little something like this let me
go ahead and open up one other file
called edges.pi and in edges.pi I'm
again going to import from the pillow
Library the image keyword and the image
filter then I'm going to go ahead and
create a before image that's a result of
calling image.open of the same thing
bridge.bmp then I'm going to go ahead
and run a filter
on that called image whoops uh image
filter dot find edges which is like a
constant if you will to find inside of
this library for us and then I'm going
to do after dot save quote unquote
out.bmp using the same file name I'm now
going to run python of edges.pi
after sorry user error we'll see what
syntax error means soon let me go ahead
and run the code now edges.pi let me now
open that new file out.pmp and before we
had this and now especially if what will
look familiar if you did the more
comfortable version of P said four
we now get this after just four lines of
code so again suggesting the power of
using a language that's better optimized
for the tool at hand and at the risk of
really making folks sad let's go ahead
and re-implement if we could problem set
five real quickly here let me go ahead
and open another version of this code
wherein I have a c version just from
problem set five when you implemented a
spell checker loading a hundred thousand
plus words into memory and then you keep
kept track of just how much time and
memory it took and that probably took a
while implementing all of those
functions in dictionary.c let me instead
now go into
a new file called dictionary.pi and let
me stipulate for the sake of discussion
that we already wrote in advance
speller.pi which corresponds to
speller.c you didn't write either of
those recall for problem set five we
gave you speller.c assume that we're
going to give you speller.pi so the onus
on us right now is only to implement
speller dictionary dot Pi all right so
I'm going to go ahead and Define a few
functions and we're going to see now the
Syntax for defining functions in Python
I want to go ahead and Define a first a
hash table which was the very first
thing you defined in dictionary.c I'm
going to go ahead then and say words
gets this give me a dictionary otherwise
known as a hash table all right now let
me Define a function called check which
was the first function you might have
implemented check is going to take a
word and you'll see in Python the syntax
is a little different you don't specify
the return type you use the word def
instead to Define you still specify the
name of the function and the any
arguments there too but you omit any
mention of types but you do use a colon
and indent so how do I check if a word
is in my dictionary or in my hash table
well in Python I can just say if word in
words go ahead and return true else go
ahead and return false done with the
check function all right now I want to
do like load that was the heavy lift
where you had to load the big file into
memory so let me Define a function
called load it takes a string the name
of a file to load so I'll call that
dictionary just like in C but no data
type let me go ahead and open a file by
using an open function in Python by
opening that dictionary in read mode so
this is a little similar to F open a
function and so you might recall then
let me iterate over every line in the
file in Python this is pretty Pleasant
for line in file colon indent how now do
I get at the current word and then strip
off the new line because in this file of
words 140 000 words there's word
backslash N word backslash n all right
well let me go ahead and get a word from
the current line but strip off from the
right end of the string the new line
which the r strip function in Python
does for me then let me go ahead and add
to my dictionary or hash table that word
done let me go ahead and close the file
for good measure and then let me go
ahead and return true because all was
well that's it for the load function in
Python how about the size function this
did not take any arguments it just
Returns the size of the hash table or
dictionary in Python I can do that by
returning the length of the dictionary
in question and then lastly gone from
the world of python is malloc and free
memory is managed for you so no matter
what I do there's nothing to unload the
computer will do that for me so I give
you in these functions problem set 5 in
Python so I'm sorry we made you write it
in C first but the implication now is
that what are you getting for free in a
language like python well encapsulated
in this one line of code is much of what
you wrote for problem set five
implementing your array for all of your
letters of the alphabet or more all of
the link lists that you implemented to
create chains to store all of those
words all of that is happening it's just
someone else in the world wrote that
code for you and you can now use it by
way of a a dictionary and actually I can
change this a little bit because add is
technically not the right function to
use here I'm actually treating the
dictionary as something simpler a set so
I'm going to make one tweak set recall
was another data type in Python but set
just allows it to handle duplicates and
it allows me to just throw things into
it by literally using a function as
simple as ADD and I'm going to make one
other tweak here because when I'm
checking a word it's possible it might
be given to me in uppercase or
capitalized it's not going to
necessarily come in in the same lower
case format that my dictionary did I can
force every word to lowercase by using
word dot lower and I don't have to do it
character for character I can do the
whole darn string At Once by just saying
word dot lower
all right let me go ahead and open up a
terminal window here and let me go into
first my C version on the left and
actually I'm going to go ahead and split
my terminal window into two and on the
right I'm going to go into a version
that I essentially just wrote but it's
also available online if you want to
play along afterward I'm going to go
ahead and make speller and C on the left
and note that it takes a moment to
compile then I'm going to be ready to
run speller of dictionaries let's do
like the Sherlock Holmes text which is
pretty big and then over here let me get
ready to run python of speller on texts
homes dot txt2 so the syntax is a little
different at the command prompt I just
on the left have to compile the code
with make and then run it with DOT slash
speller on the right I don't need to
compile it but I do need to use The
Interpreter so even though the lines are
wrapping a little bit here let me go
ahead and run it on the right and I'm
going to count how long it takes
verbally for demonstration's sake
One Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi okay so it's like three
seconds give or take
now running it in Python keeping in mind
I spent way fewer hours implementing a
spell checker in Python than you might
have in problem set five but what's the
trade-off going to be and what kinds of
design decisions do we all now need to
be making consciously here we go on the
right in Python
One Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi four Mississippi five
Mississippi six Mississippi seven
Mississippi eight Mississippi nine
Mississippi 10 Mississippi 11
Mississippi all right so 10 or 11
seconds
so which one is better let's like go to
the group here which of these programs
is the better one how might you answer
that question based on demonstration
alone
what do you think
[Music]
okay so python to summarize is better
for the programmer because it was way
faster to write but C is maybe better
for the computer because it's much
faster to run I think that's a
reasonable formulation other opinions
yeah
I think it depends on the size of the
project that you're dealing with so if
it's going to be something that's
relatively quick I might not care that
it takes 10 seconds to do it and it took
me way faster with python whereas and
see if I'm dealing with something like
dudes that that time is going to really
build up on it might be worth it to put
in The Upfront effort and just loading
it and see so the process continually
runs faster over
okay absolutely a really good answer and
let me summarize is it depends on the
workload if you will if you were to you
if you have a very large data set you
might want to optimize your code to be
as fast and performant as it can be
especially if you're running that code
again and again maybe you're a company
like Google people are searching a huge
database all the time you really want to
squeeze every bit of performance as you
can out of the computer you might want
to have someone smart take a language
like C and write it at a very low level
it's going to be painful they're going
to have bugs they're going to have to
deal with memory management and like but
if and when it works correctly it's
going to be much faster it would seem by
contrast if you have a data set that's
big and 140 000 words is not small but
you don't want to spend like five hours
10 hours a week of your time building a
spell checker or dictionary you can
instead leverage a different language
with different libraries and build on
top of it in order to prioritize the
human time instead other thoughts
[Music]
that perfect segue to exactly the next
point we wanted to make which was is
there something in between and indeed
there is I'm oversimplifying what this
language is actually doing it's not as
Stark a difference as saying like hey
python is four times slower than C like
that's not the right takeaway there are
absolutely ways that Engineers can
optimize languages as they have already
done for Python and in fact I've
configured my settings in such a way
that I've kind of dramatized just how
big the difference is it is going to be
slower python typically than the
equivalent C program but it doesn't have
to be as big of a gap as it is here
because indeed among the features you
can turn on in Python is to save some
intermediate results technically
speaking yes python is interpreting uh
dictionary dot pi and these other files
translating them from one language to
another but that doesn't mean it has to
do that every darn time you run the
program as you propose you can save or
Cache CAC e the result of that process
so that the second time and the third
time are actually notably faster and in
fact python itself The Interpreter the
most popular version thereof itself is
actually implemented in C so you can
make sure that your interpreter is as
fast as possible and what then is maybe
the high level takeaway yes if you are
going to try to squeeze every bit of
performance out of your code and maybe
code is constrained you maybe you have
very small devices maybe it's like a
watch nowadays or maybe it's a sensor
that's installed in some small format in
an appliance or in infrastructure where
you don't have much battery life and you
don't have much size you might want to
minimize just how much work is being
done and so the faster the code runs and
the better it's going to be if it's
implemented something low level so C is
still very commonly used for certain
types of applications but again if you
just want to solve real world problems
and get real work done and your time is
just as if not more valuable than the
device you're running it on long term
you know what python is among the most
popular line languages as well and
frankly if I were implementing a spell
checker moving forward I'm probably
starting with python I'm not going to
waste time implementing all of that low
level stuff because the whole point of
using newer modern languages is to use
abstractions that other people have
created for you and by abstraction I
mean something like the dictionary
function that just gives you a
dictionary or hash table or the
equivalent version that I used which in
this case was a set
all right any questions then on python
thus far
no all right let's oh yeah in the middle
[Music]
I'm not sure
it feels like
really good question or observation
could you just compile python code yes
absolutely this idea of compiling code
or interpreting code is not native to
the language itself it tends to be
native to the conventions that we humans
use so you could actually write an
interpreter for C that would read it top
to bottom left to right converting it to
on the fly something the computer under
the computer understands but
historically that's not been the case C
is generally a compiled language but it
doesn't have to be what python nowadays
is actually doing is what you described
earlier it technically is sort of
unbeknownst to us compiling the code
technically not into zeros and ones
technically into something called byte
code which is this intermediate step
that just doesn't take as much time as
it would to recompile the whole thing
and this is an area of research for
computer scientists working in
programming languages to improve these
kinds of paradigms why well honestly for
you and I the programmer it's just much
easier to one run the code and not worry
about the stupid second step of
compiling it all the time why it's
literally half as many steps for me the
human and that's a nice thing to
optimize for and ultimately two you
might want all of the fancy features
that come with these other languages so
you should really just be fine-tuning
how you can enable these features as
opposed to shying away from them here
and in fact the only time I personally
ever you see is from like September to
October of every year during cs50 almost
every other month do I reach for python
or another language called JavaScript to
actually get real work done which is not
to impune C it's just that those other
languages tend to be better fits for the
amount of time I have to allocate and
the types of problems that I want to
solve all right let's go ahead and take
a five minute break here and when we
come back we'll start writing some
programs from scratch
all right so let's go ahead and start
writing some code from the beginning
here whereby we start small with some
simple examples and then we'll build our
way up to more sophisticated examples in
Python but what we'll do along the way
is First Look side by side at what the C
code looked like way back in week one or
two or three and so forth and then write
the corresponding python code it right
and then we'll transition just to
focusing on python itself what I've done
in advance today is I've downloaded some
of the code from the course's website my
source 6 directory which contains all of
the pre-written C code from weeks past
but it'll also have copies of the Python
code will right here together and look
at so first here is hello.c back from
week zero this was version zero of it
I'm going to go ahead and do this I'm
going to go ahead and split my code
window up here I'm going to go ahead and
create a new file called hello.pi and
this isn't something you'll typically
have to do laying your code out side by
side but I've just clicked the little
icon in vs code that looks like two
columns that splits my code editor into
two places so that we can in fact see
things for now side by side with my
terminal window down below all right now
I'm going to go ahead and write the
corresponding Python program on the
right which recall was just print quote
unquote hello world and that's it now
down in my terminal window I'm going to
go ahead and run python of hello.pi
enter and voila we've got hello.pi
working so again I'm not going to play
any further with the c code it's there
just to jog your memory left and right
so let's now look at a second version of
hello world from that first week whereby
if I go and get hello 1.c I'm going to
drag that over to the right whoops I'm
going to go ahead and drag that over to
the left here and now on the right let's
modify hello.pi to look a little more
like this second version in C all right
I want to get a uh answer from the user
as a return value but I also want to get
some input from them so from cs50 I'm
going to import the function called get
string for now we're going to get rid of
that eventually but for now it's a
helpful training wheel and then down
here I'm going to say answer equals get
string quote unquote what's your name
question mark space but no semicolon no
data type and then I'm going to go ahead
and print just like the first example on
the slide hello comma space plus answer
and now let me go ahead and run this
python hello.pi all right it's asking me
what's my name David hello comma David
but it's worth calling attention to the
fact that I've also
simplified further it's not just that
the individual functions are simpler
what is also now glaringly omitted from
my python code at write both in this
version and the previous version what
did I not bother implementing
yeah so I didn't even need to implement
main we'll revisit the main function
because having a main function actually
does solve problems sometimes but it's
no longer required and see you have to
have that to kick start the entire
process of actually running your code
and in fact if you were missing main as
you might have experienced if you
accidentally compiled helpers.c instead
of the file that contained main you
would have seen a compiler error in
Python it's not necessary python you can
just jump right in start programming and
boom you're good to go especially if
it's a small program like this you don't
need the added overhead or complexity of
a main function so that's one other
difference here all right there are a
few other ways we could say hello world
recall that I could use a format string
so I could put this whole thing in
quotes I could use this F prefix and
then let me go ahead and run python if
hello.pi again you can perhaps see where
we're going with this let me type my
name David and here we go okay that's
the mistake that someone identified
earlier you need the curly braces
otherwise no variables are interpolated
that is substituted with their actual
values so if I go back in and add those
curly braces to the F string now let me
run python of hello.pi type in my name
and there we go we're back in business
which one's better I mean it depends but
generally speaking making shorter more
concise code tends to be a good thing so
stylistically the F string is probably a
reasonable instinct to have all right
well what more can we do besides this
well let me go ahead here and let's get
rid of the training wheel altogether
actually so same C code at left let me
get rid of the cs50 library which we
will ultimately in a couple of weeks
anyway I can't use get string but I can
use a function that comes with python
called input and in fact this is
actually a one for one substitution
pretty much there's really no downside
to using input instead of get string we
Implement get string just for
consistency with what you saw in C
python of hello.pi what's your name
David still actually works the same so
gone or the cs50 specific training
wheels but we're going to bring them
back shortly just to deal with integers
or Floats or other values too because
it's going to make our lives a little
simpler with error checking all right
any questions before we now pivot to
revisiting other examples from week one
but now in Python
all right let me go ahead and open up
now let's say calculator 0.c which was
one of the first examples we did
involving math and operators like that
as well as functions like get int let me
go ahead and create a new file now
called calculator dot Pi at right so
that I have my C code at left still and
my python code at right all right let me
go dive into a translation of this code
into python I am going to use get int
from the csrt library so let me import
that I'm going to go ahead now and get
an INT from the user so x equals get int
and I'll ask them for an x value just
like we did weeks ago no need to specify
a semicolon though or a int for the X it
will just figure it out Y is going to
get another int via y colon and then
down here I'm going to go ahead and say
print of X Plus y so this is already a
bit new recall the C version required
that I use this format string as well as
printf itself Python's just a little
more user friendly all you want to do is
print out a value like X Plus y just
print it don't fuss with any percent
signs or format codes it's not printf
it's indeed just print now all right let
me go ahead and run python of calculator
dot Pi enter and just do a quick sample
one plus two indeed equals three as an
aside suppose I had taken a different
approach to importing the whole cs50
Library functionally it's the same
you're not going to notice any
performance impact here it's a small
library but notice what does not work
now whereas it did work in C python of
calculator.pi enter
we see our first Trace back deliberately
here so a trace back is just a term of
art that says here is a trace back
through all of the functions that just
got executed in the world of scene you
might call this a stack Trace stack
being the Opera operative word recall
that when we talked about the stack and
the Heap the stack like a stack of trays
was all of the functions that might get
called one after the other we had Maine
we had swap then swap went away and then
Maine finished recall so here's a
traceback of all the functions or code
that got executed there's not really any
functions other than my file itself
otherwise there'd be more detail but
even though it's a little cryptic we can
perhaps infer from the output here name
error so something related to the name
of something name get int is not defined
and this of course happens on line three
over there all right so why is that well
python essentially allows us to name
space our functions that come from
libraries there was a problem in C if
you were using the cs50 library and thus
had access to get ink get string and so
forth you could not you use another
library that had the same function names
they would Collide and the compiler
would not know how to link them together
correctly in Python and other languages
like JavaScript and in Java you have a
support for effectively what would be
called namespaces you can isolate
variables and function names to like
their own namespace like their own
container in memory and what this means
is if you import all of cs50 you have to
say that the get int you want is inside
the cs50 Library so just like with the
image blurring and the image edges
before where I had to specify image dot
in image filter dot similarly here am I
specifying with a DOT operator albeit a
little differently than I want
cs50.getint in both places and now if I
rerun pythonofcalculator.pi one and two
now we're back in business which one is
better generally speaking
it depends on just how many functions
you're using from the library if you're
using a whole bunch of functions just
import the whole thing if you're only
using maybe one or two import them line
by line
all right so let's go ahead and make a
little tweak here let's get rid of this
library and take this training wheel off
too as quickly as we introduced it
though for the problem set six you'll be
able to use all of these same functions
suppose I get rid of this and I just use
the input function just like I did
by replacing get string earlier let me
go ahead now and run this version of the
code python of calculator.pi
okay how about one plus two equals three
huh
all right obviously wrong incorrect can
anyone explain what just happened based
on instincts
what just happened here yeah
[Music]
sure yeah
exactly python is interpreting boat or
treating both X and Y as strings which
is actually what the input function
returns by default and so plus is now
being interpreted as concatenation as we
defined it earlier so X Plus Y is an X
Plus y mathematically but in terms of
string joining just like in scratch so
that's why we're getting 12 or really
one two which isn't itself a number it2
is another string so we somehow need to
convert things and we didn't have this
ability quite as easily in C we did have
like the a to I function ASCII to
integer which did allow you to do this
the analog in Python is actually just to
do a cast a Typecast using int so just
like in C you can use the keyword int
but use it a little differently notice
that I'm not doing parenthesis int close
parenthesis before the value I'm using
int as a function so indeed function in
Python int is a function float is a
function that you can pass values into
to do this kind of conversion so now now
if I run python of calculator dot Pi 1
and 2 now we're back in business and
getting the answer of 3. but there's
kind of a catch here there's always
going to be a trade-off like that sounds
amazing that it just works in this way
we can throw away the cs50 library
already but what if the user
accidentally types or maliciously types
in like a cat instead of a number damn
well there's one of these Trace backs
like now my program has crashed this is
similar in spirit to the kinds of seg
faults that you might have had in C but
they're not seg faults per se it doesn't
necessarily relate to memory this time
it relates to actual runtime values not
being as expected so this time it's not
a name error it's a value error invalid
literal for INT with base 10 quote
unquote cat so again it's written for
sort of a programmer more than
um sort of a typical person because it's
pretty arcane the language here but
let's try to interpret it invalid
literal a literal is just something
someone typed for INT which is the
function name with base 10 it says
defaulting to decimal numbers cat is
apparently not a decimal number doesn't
look like it therefore can't be treated
like it therefore there's a value error
so what can we do unfortunately you
would have to somehow catch this error
and the only way to do that in Python
really is by way of another feature that
c did not have namely what are called
exceptions an exception is exactly what
just happened name error value error
they are things that can go wrong when
your python code is running that aren't
necessarily going to be detected until
you run your code so in Python and in
JavaScript and in Java in other more
modern languages there's this ability to
actually try to do something except if
something goes wrong and in fact I'm
going to introduce a bit of syntax here
even though we won't have to use this
much just yet instead of just blindly
converting X to an INT let me go ahead
and try to do that and if there's an
exception go ahead and say something
like uh
print
uh
that is not an INT and then I'm going to
do something like exit right there and
let me go ahead and do this here let me
try to get y except if there's an
exception then let me go ahead and say
again that is not an INT exclamation
point and then I'm going to exit from
there too otherwise I'll go ahead and
print X Plus y if I run python if
calculator.pi now whoops uh
oh forgot my close quote sorry
all right so close quote python of
calculator dot Pi uh one and two still
work but if I try to type in something
wrong like cat now it actually detects
the error so what is the cs50 library in
Python doing it's actually doing that
try and accept for you because suffice
it to say otherwise your programs for
something simple like a calculator start
to get longer and longer so we factored
that kind of logic out to the cs50 get
int function and get float function but
underneath the hood they're essentially
doing this try accept but they're being
a little more precise they're detecting
a specific error and they are doing it
in a loop so that these functions will
get executed again and again in fact the
best way to do this is to say except if
there's a value error then print that
error message out to the user and again
let's not get too into the weeds here
with this feature we've already put it
into the cs50 library but that's why for
instance we bootstrap things by just
using these functions out of the box
all right let's do something more with
our calculator here how about this in
the world of C we had another version of
this code which actually did some
division by way of
um which actually did division of
numbers not just
the addition herein so let me go ahead
and close the C version and let's focus
only on python now doing some of these
same lines of codes but I'm going to go
ahead and just assume that the user is
going to cooperate and use proper input
so from cs50 import get int that'll deal
with any errors for me X gets uh get int
ask the user for an into x y equals get
int ask the user for an into Y and then
let's go ahead and do this let's declare
a variable called Z set it equal to x
divided by y then let's go ahead and
print Z still no need for a format
string I can just print out the
variables value let me go ahead and run
python of calculator.pi let me do 1 10
and I get 0.1 what did I get in C though
if you think back
what do we have to happen and see
yeah we would have gotten zero in C but
Y in C when you divide one inch by
another and those ins are like one in
ten respectively
it will give you what
it will give you an integer back and
unfortunately 0.1 the integer part of it
is indeed zero so this was an example of
truncation so truncation was an issue in
C but it would seem as though this is no
longer a problem in python insofar as
the division operator actually handles
that for us as an aside if you want the
old Behavior because it actually is
sometimes useful for rounding or
flooring values you can actually use two
slashes and now you get the C Behavior
so that now one divided by ten is zero
so you don't give up that capability but
at least it does a more sensible default
most people especially new programmers
when dividing one value by another would
want to get 0.1 not zero for reasons
that indeed we had to explain weeks ago
but what about another problem we had
with the world of floats before whereby
there was in Precision let me go ahead
and somewhat cryptically print out the
value of Z as follows I'm going to
format it using an F string and I'm
going to go ahead and format not just Z
because this is essentially the same
thing notice this if I do python of
calculator.pi 1 and 10 I get by default
just one significant digit but if I use
this syntax in Python which we won't
have to use often I can actually do and
see like I did before 50 significant
digits after the decimal point so now
let me rerun python of calculator.pi 1
and 10 and let's see if floating point
and precision is still with us
unfortunately it is and you can see as
much here the F string the format string
is just showing us now 50 digits instead
of the default one so we've not solved
all problems but we have solved at least
some all right before we pivot away from
a mirror calculator any questions now
on syntax or concepts or the like yeah
[Music]
how do you what oh how do you comment
really good question if you're using
double slash for division with flooring
or truncation like I describe how do you
do a comment in Python this is a comment
and the convention is actually to use a
complete sentence like uh with a capital
T here you don't need a period unless
there's multiple sentences and
technically it should be above the line
of Code by convention so you would use a
hash symbol instead good question
haven't seen those yet all right let's
go ahead and make something else here
how about let me go ahead and open up
for instance an example called
points1.c which we saw a few weeks back
and let me go ahead on the other side
and create a file called points.pi this
was a program recall that asked the user
how many points they lost on uh the
first assignment and then it went ahead
and just printed out whether they lost
fewer points than me because I lost two
if you recall the photo more points than
me or the same points as me let me go
ahead and zoom out so we can see a bit
more of this and let me now on the top
right here go about implementing this in
Python so I want to First prompt the
user for some number of points so from
cs50 let's import get in so it handles
the error checking let's then do points
equals get int and ask the user how many
points did you lose question mark then
let's go ahead and say if points less
than 2 which was my value print you lost
fewer points than me otherwise if it's
else if points greater than 2 go ahead
and print
uh you lost more points than me
else let's go ahead and handle the final
scenario which is you lost the same
number of points as me before I run this
does anyone want to point out a mistake
I've already made yeah
[Music]
yeah so else if in C is actually now L
if in Python it's a single word so let
me change this to L if and now cross my
fingers python of points.pi suppose you
lost three points on some assignment you
lost more points than my two if you only
lost one point you lost fewer points
than me so the logic is the same but
notice the code is much tighter in 10
Total Lines we did in what was 424 lines
because we've thrown away a lot of the
syntax the curly braces are no longer
necessary the parentheses are gone the
semicolons so this is why it just tends
to be more pleasant pretty quickly using
a language like this
all right let's do one other example
here
um in C recall that we were able to
determine the parity of some number if
something is even or odd well in Python
let me go ahead and create a file called
parity.pi and let's look for a moment at
the C version at left here was the code
in C that we used to determine the
parity of a number and really the key
takeaway from all these lines was just
the remainder operator and that one is
still with us so this is a simple
demonstration just to make that point if
in Python I want to determine whether a
number is even or odd well let's go
ahead and from cs50 import get int then
let's go ahead and get a number like n
from the user using get int and ask them
for n and then let's go ahead and say if
n percent sign 2 equals zero then let's
go ahead and print quote unquote even
else let's go ahead and print out odd
but before I run this
anyone want to instinctively even though
we've not talked about this point out a
mistake here
would I do wrong
yeah so double equals again so even
though some of the stuff is changing
some of the same ideas are the same so
this two should be a double equal sign
because I'm comparing for equality here
and why is this the right math well if
you divide a number by two it's either
going to have zero or one as a remainder
and that's going to determine if it's
even or odd for us so let's run python
of parity dot Pi type in a number like
50 and hopefully we get indeed even so
again same idea but now we're down to
eight lines of code instead of the 20.
well let's now do something a little
more interactive and a little
representative of tools that actually
ask the user questions in C recall that
we had this agreement program agree.c
and then let's go ahead and Implement a
corresponding version in Python in a
file called agree dot pi and let's look
at the C version first on the left we
used get Char here and then we use the
double vertical bars to check if C is
equal to Capital y or lowercase Y and
then we did the same thing for n for no
and so let's go over here and let's do
from cs50 import get okay get Char is
not a thing and this here is another
difference with python there is no data
type for individual characters you have
strings stirs and honestly those are
fine because if you have a stir that's
just one character for all intents and
purposes it is just a single character
so it's just a simplification you don't
have to think as much you don't have to
worry about double quotes single quotes
in fact in Python you can use double
quotes or single quotes so long as
you're consistent so long as you're
consistent the single quotes do not mean
something different like they do in C so
I'm going to go ahead and use get string
here although strictly speaking I could
just use the input function as we saw
before I'm going to get a string from
the user that asks them this get string
quote unquote do you agree like a little
check box or interactive prompt do we
have to say yes or no you want to agree
to the following terms or whatnot and
then let's translate the conditionals to
python now too so if s equals equals
quote unquote y
or S equals equals lowercase y let's go
ahead and print out agreed just like in
c l if s equals equals n or S equals
equals little n let's go ahead then and
print out not agreed and you can already
see perhaps one of the differences here
too is python a little more english-like
in that you just literally use the
English word or instead of the two
vertical bars but it's ultimately doing
the same thing
can we simplify this code a bit though
this would be a little Annoying if we
wanted to add support not just for Big Y
and little y but yes or big yes or
little yes or Big Y Lowery case e
capital s right there's a lot of
permutations of y-e-s or just y that we
ideally should tolerate otherwise the
user has gonna have to type exactly what
we want which isn't very user friendly
any intuition for how we could logically
even if you don't know how to do it in
code make this better yeah
nice yeah we saw an example of a list
before just 0 1 2 why don't we take that
same idea and ask a similar question If
s is in the following list of values y
or little y or heck let me add to the
list now yes or maybe all capital yes
and it's going to get a little Annoying
admittedly but this is still better than
the alternative with all the ores I
could do things like this and so forth
there's a whole bunch more permutations
but let's leave this alone and let me
just go into here and change this to If
s is in the following list of n
or little n or no and I won't do as
let's just not worry about the weird
capitalizations there for now let's go
ahead and run this python of agree.pi do
I agree why okay how about yes all right
how about big yes okay that does not
seem to work notice it did not say
agreed and it did not say not agreed it
didn't detect it so how can I do this
well you know what I could do
what I don't really need the uppercase
and lowercase let me tighten this list
up a little bit and why don't I just
force s to be lowercase s dot lower
recall whether it's one character or
more is a function built into stirs now
strings in Python that forces the whole
thing to lower case so now watch what I
can do python of agree dot PI Little y
that works Big Y that works big yes that
works Big Y little e big S that also
works so we've now handled in one Fell
Swoop a whole bunch more logic and you
know what we can tighten this up a bit
here's an opportunity in Python for
slightly better design what have I done
in here that's a little redundant
does anyone see an opportunity
to eliminate a redundancy doing
something more than times than you need
is a stretcher no yep
we could move the s dot lower above
notice that I'm using s dot lower twice
but it's going to give me the same
answer both times so I could do a couple
of things here I could first of all get
rid of this lower and get rid of this
lower
and then Above This maybe I could do
something like this s equal I can't just
do this because that throws the value
away it does the math but it doesn't
convert the string itself it's going to
return a value so I have to say s equals
s dot lower I could do that or honestly
I can chain these things together and
this is not something we saw and see if
get string returns a string and strings
have functions like lower in them you
can chain these functions together like
this and do dot this dot that dot this
other thing and eventually you want to
stop because it's going to become crazy
long but this is reasonable still fits
on the screen it's pretty tight it does
in one place what I was doing in two so
I think that's okay let me go ahead and
do python of agree.pi one last time
let's try it one last time and it's
still working as intended it's also if I
tried those other inputs as well yeah
question
[Music]
case as well or like upper and then
cover all the functions where it's
lowercase four all functions
of course they do not put those together
um let me summarize could we could we
handle uppercase and lowercase together
in some form I'm actually doing that
already I just have to pick a lane I
have to either be all lowercase in my
logic or all uppercase and not worry
about what the human types in because no
matter what the human types in I'm
forcing their input to lower case and
then I am using a lowercase list of
values if I want to flip that fine I
just have to be self-consistent but I'm
handling that already yeah
[Music]
a really good loaded questions are
strings no longer an array of characters
conceptually yes underneath the hood no
they're a little more sophisticated than
that because with strings you have a few
changes not only do they have functions
built into them because strings are now
what we call objects in what's called
object oriented programming and we're
going to keep seeing examples of this
dot operator they are also immutable so
to speak
i-m-m-u-t-a-b-l-e immutable means they
cannot be changed which means unlike C
you can't go into a string and change
its individual characters you can make a
copy of the string that makes a change
but you can't change the original string
itself this is both a little Annoying
maybe sometimes but it's also pretty
protective because you can't do
screw-ups like I did weeks ago when I
was trying to copy s and call it t and
then one affected the other python
underneath the hood is handling all of
the memory management and the pointers
and all of that there are no pointers in
pythons if that wasn't clear all of that
pain if you will all of that power is
now handled by the language itself not
by us the programmers
all right so let's introduce maybe some
Loops like we've been uh in the habit of
doing let me open up meow.c which was an
example in C just meowing a bunch of
times textually let me create a file
called meow.pi here on the right and
notice on the left this was correct code
in C but it was kind of poorly designed
why because it was a missed opportunity
for a loop why say something three times
when you can say it just once so in
Python let me do it the poorly designed
way first let me print out meow and like
I generally should not let me copy paste
it three times run pythonofmeow.pi and
it works okay but not good practice so
let me go ahead and improve this a
little bit and there's a few ways to do
this if I wanted to do this three times
I could instead do something like this
for I in range of three recall that that
was the better version rather than
arbitrarily enumerate numbers yourself
let me go ahead and print out quote
unquote meow now if I run python of meow
still seems to work so it's a little
tighter in my God like programs can't
really get much shorter than this we're
down to two lines of code no main
function no gratuitous syntax let's now
improve the design further like we did
in C by introducing a function called
meow that actually does the meowing so
this was our first abstraction recall
both in scratch and in C let me Focus
now entirely on the python version here
let me go ahead and first uh Define a
function
let me first go ahead and do this for I
in range of three let's assume for the
moment that there's a meow function that
I'm just going to call let's now go
ahead and Define using the def keyword
which we saw briefly with the speller uh
demonstration a function called meow
that takes no arguments and all it does
for now is print meow let me now go
ahead and run python of meow.pi enter
one of those Trace backs so this is
another name error and again name meow
is not defined
what's your instinct here even though
we've not tripped over this yet in
Python where does your mind go here
[Music]
perfect as smart as as smarter as python
seems to be it also it still makes
certain assumptions and if it hasn't
seen a keyword yet it just doesn't exist
so if you want it to exist we have to be
a little clever here I could just put it
flip it around like this but this
honestly isn't particularly good design
why because now if you the reader of
your code whether you wrote it or
someone else you kind of have to go
fishing now like where does this program
begin and even though yes it's obviously
that it begins on line four logically
like if the trial were longer you're
going to be annoyed in fishing visually
for the right lines of code so let's
reintroduce Main and indeed this would
be a common Paradigm when you want to
start having abstractions and your own
functions just put your own code in main
so that one you can leave it up top and
two you can solve the problem we just
encountered so let me Define a function
called main that has that same Loop
meowing three times but now Watch What
Happens let me go into my terminal and
run python of meow.pi enter
nothing
all right
investigate this what could explain this
symptom I have not told you the answer
yet so all you have is your instinct
assuming you've never touched python
before
What might explain this symptom where
nothing is meowing
yeah
yeah I didn't run the main function so
in C this is functionality you get for
free you have to have a main function
but heck so long as you make it it will
be called for you in Python this is just
a convention to create a main function
borrowing a very common name for but if
you want to call that main function you
have to do it so this looks a little
weird admittedly that you have to call
your own main function now and it has to
be at the bottom of the file because
only once The Interpreter gets to the
bottom of the file have all of your
functions been defined higher up but
this solves both problems it keeps your
code that's the main part of your code
at the very top of the file so it's just
obvious to you and a TF or any reader in
the future where the programs logically
starts but it also ensures that main is
not called until everything else made
included has been defined so this is
another perfect example of we're
learning a new language for the first
time you're not going to have heard all
the answers before just apply some logic
as to like all right what could explain
this symptom start to infer how the
language does or doesn't work if I now
go and run this pythonofmeow.pi now
we're back in business and just so you
have seen it there is a quote unquote
better way of doing this that solves
different problems that we are not going
to encounter certainly in these initial
days typically you would see an online
tutorials or books something that looks
like this where you actually have a
weird conditional with multiple
underscores that's functionally the same
thing but it solves problems with
libraries if we ourselves were
implementing a library or something
similar in spirit but we're going to
keep things simpler and just write main
at the bottom because we're not going to
encounter that problem just yet all
right let's make one change to this just
to show how it's done in C the last
version of meow also took command line
argue sorry also took arguments to the
function meow so suppose that I want to
factor this out and I want to just call
meow as a better abstraction where I
just say meow this number of times and I
figure out how many times by just like
putting in number three or using get int
or something like that to figure out how
many times to say meow well now I have
to Define inside my meow function in
input let's call it n and then use that
as by doing this for I in range of n
let me go ahead and print out meow that
many times so again the only thing
that's different in C is we don't bother
specifying return types for any of these
functions and we don't bother specifying
the type of our arguments or our
variables so same idea is simpler in
some sense we're just throwing away
keystrokes all right let me run this one
final time python of meow.pi and we
still have the same program
all right let me pause here any
questions and I know this is going fast
but hopefully the C code is still
somewhat familiar
yeah
good question is there any difference
between Global and local variables short
answer yes and we would run into that
same problem if we declare a variable in
one function another function is not
going to have access to it we can solve
that by putting variables globally but
we don't have all of the features we had
in seed like there's no such thing as a
constant in Python the mentality in the
python Community is if you don't want
some value to change don't touch it like
just don't screw up so there's
trade-offs here too some languages are
stronger or more defensive than that but
that too is pyter of the mindset with
this particular language
[Music]
oh sorry where's say a ladder
that is an amazing segue let's come to
that in just a moment because we're
going to recreate also that Mario
example where we had like the um
question marks for the coins and the
vertical bar so let's come back to that
in a second and your question
[Music]
correct strings are immutable anytime
you seem to be modifying it as with the
lower function you're getting back a
copy so it's taking a little more memory
somewhere but you don't have to deal
with it Python's doing that for you
[Music]
say it again you don't need what
you don't free anything so if you
weren't a big fan over the past couple
of weeks of malloc or free or memory or
addresses or all of those low-level
implementation details python is the
language for you because all of that is
handled for you automatically Java does
the same JavaScript does the same yeah
[Music]
how do you define a global variable if
there's no main function in Python
Global variables by definition always
need to be outside of Maine as well so
that's not a problem if I wanted to have
a function that's outside of and
therefore Global to all of these like
Global actually don't use the word
Global that's a special word in Python a
variable equals foo foo just as an
arbitrary string value that a computer
scientist would typically use that is
now global there are some caveats though
as to how you access that but let's come
back to that another time but that
problem is solvable too all right so
let's go ahead and do this to come back
to the question about the print command
let me go ahead and create a file now
called mario.pi won't bother showing the
C code anymore we'll focus just on the
new language here but recall that in
Python in Mario we wanted to First do
something like this this was a random
screen from the side scroller version
one of my Super Mario Brothers and we
just want to print like three hashes to
represent those three blocks well in
Python we could do something like this
print oh sorry for I in the range of
three go ahead and print out quote
unquote hash and I think this is pretty
straightforward python of mario.pi we
get our three hashes you could imagine
parameterizing this now though and
getting actual user input so let's do
that let me go up here and let me go and
say from cs50 import get int and then
let's get the input from the user so it
actually is a value n like all right get
int the height of the column of bricks
that you want to do and then let's go
ahead and print out n hashes instead of
three so let me run this let's print out
like five hashes okay one two three four
five that seems to work too and it's
going to work for any positive value but
it's not going to work for how about
negative one that just doesn't do
anything but that seems okay but also
recall that it's not going to work if if
the user types in something weird like
oh sorry it is going to work if the user
types in something weird like cat why
we're using cs50s get int function which
is handling all of those headaches for
us but what if the user indeed types a
negative number we're tolerating that so
that was the bug I wanted to highlight
it would be nice to re-prompt them and
reprompt them and in C what was the
programming construct we used when we
wanted to ask the user a question and
then if they didn't cooperate prompt
them again prompt them again
what was that yeah yeah do while loop
right that was useful because it's
almost the same as a while loop but
instead of checking a condition and then
doing something you do something and
then check a condition which makes sense
with user input because what are you
even going to check if the user hasn't
done anything yet you need that inverted
logic unfortunately in Python there is
no do while loop there is a for Loop
there is a while loop and frankly those
are enough to recreate this idea and the
way to do this in Python the pythonic
way which is another term of Art in the
community is to say this deliberately
induce an infinite Loop while true with
capital T for true and then do what you
got to do like get an INT from a user
asking them for the height of this thing
and then if that is what you want like a
number greater than zero go ahead and
break out of the loop so this is how in
Python you could recreate the idea of a
do while loop you deliberately induce an
infinite Loop so something's going to
happen at least once then if you get the
answer you want you break out of it
effectively achieving the same logic so
this is the pythonic way of doing a do
while loop let me go ahead and run
python of mario.pi type in three this
time and now I get back just the three
hashes as well what if though I wanted
to get rid of
uh how about ultimately that cs50
Library function and also encapsulate
this in a function well let's go ahead
and tweak this a little bit let me go
ahead and remove this temporarily give
myself a main function so I don't make
the same mistake as I did initially
earlier and let me give myself a
function called get height that takes no
arguments and inside of that function is
going to be that same code but I don't
want to break in this case I want to
return n so recall that if you return
from a function you're done you're going
to exit from right that point so this
would be fine you can just say return n
inside of the loop or if you would
prefer to break out you could do
something like this instead break
and then down here you could return
down here you could return n as well and
let me make one point here before we go
back up to main this is a little
different from C and this one's subtle
what have I done here that in C would
have been a bug
but is apparently not I claim in Python
super subtle this one yeah
[Music]
so so similar it's not quite that we're
using it for so it's okay not to declare
a variable with like the data type we've
addressed that before but on line nine
we're assigning and a value it seems and
then we return uh n on line 12 but
notice the indentation in the world of C
if we had declared a variable inside of
a loop on line nine it would have been
scoped to that Loop which means as soon
as you get out of that Loop like further
down in the program n would not exist it
would be local to the curly braces
they're in here logically curly braces
are gone but the indentation makes clear
that n is still inside of this Loop
between lines 8 through 11 but n is
actually still in scope in Python the
moment you create a variable in Python
For Better or For Worse it is available
everywhere within that function even
outside of the loop in which you defined
it so this logic is actually okay in
Python in C recall to solve this same
problem we would have had to do
something a little package like this
like Define n up here on line eight so
that it exists now on line 10 and so
that it exists on line 13 that is no
longer an issue or need in Python once
you create a variable even if it's
nested nested nested inside of Some
Loops or conditionals it still exists
within the function itself
all right any questions then on on this
before we now run this and then get rid
of the cs50 library again
[Music]
okay so let me go ahead and get the
height from the user let's go ahead and
create a variable in main called height
let's call this get height function and
then let's use that height value instead
of something hard coded there and let me
see if this all works now python of
mario.pi hopefully I haven't messed up
but I did but this is an easy fix now
yeah
I gotta call Maine so again I deleted
that earlier but let me bring it back so
I'm actually calling main let me rerun
uh python of mario.pi there we go height
three now it seems to be working so
let's do one last thing with Mario just
to tie together that idea now of
exceptions from before again exceptions
are a feature of python whereby you can
try to do something and if there's a
problem you can handle it in any way you
see fit previously I handled it by just
yelling at the user that that's not an
INT but let's actually use this to
re-implement cs50's own get int function
let me throw away cs50's get in function
and now let me go ahead
and replace uh get int with input but
it's not sufficient to just use input
what do I have to add to this line of
code on line a
if I want to get back in int
yeah I have to cast it to an end by
calling the int function around that
value or I could do it on a separate
line just to be clear I could also do n
equals int of n that would work too but
it's sort of an unnecessary extra line
This is not sufficient because that does
not change the value it creates the
value but then it throws it away you
need to assign it to the conventional
way to do this would probably be in one
line just to keep things nice and tight
so that works fine now if I run python
of mario.pi I can still type in 3 and
all as well I can still type in negative
one because that is an INT that I am
handling what I'm not yet handling is
weird input like cats or some string
that is not a base 10 number so here
again is my Trace back and notice that
here let me scroll up a little bit
here we can actually see more detail in
the trace back notice that just like in
C or just like in the debugger in vs
code you can see a few things you can
see mention of module that just means
your file main which is my main function
and get height so notice it's kind of
backwards it's top to bottom instead of
bottom up as we drew it on the board the
other day and as we envisioned stacks of
trays in the cafeteria but this is your
stack of functions that have been called
from top to bottom get height is the
most recent main is the very first value
error is the problem so let's try to do
let's try to do this literally except if
there's an error so what do I want to do
I'm going to go in here and I'm going to
say try to do the following
whoops try to do the following except
if there's a value error value error
then go ahead and say something like
well like before print that's not an
integer exclamation point But the
difference this time is because I'm in a
loop the user is going to have a chance
to recover from this issue so if I run
mario.pi 3 still works as before if I
run mario.pi and type in cat I detect it
now and because I'm still in that Loop
and because the program hasn't crashed
because I've caught so to speak the
value error using this line of code here
that's the way in Python to detect these
kinds of errors that would otherwise end
up being on the user's own screen if I
type in cat dog that doesn't work if I
type in the two I get my two hashes
because that's indeed an INT
are any questions on this and we're not
going to spend too much time on
exceptions but just wanted to show you
what's involved with getting rid of
those training wheels yeah
okay so let's do this that actually
comes to the earlier question about
printing the hashes on the same line or
maybe something like this where we have
little bricks in the sky or little
question marks let's recreate this idea
because the problem with print as was
noted earlier is you're automatically
printing out new lines but what if we
don't want that well let's change this
program entirely let me throw away all
the functions let's just go to a simpler
world where we're just doing this so let
me start fresh in marioed up high I'm
not going to bother with exceptions or
functions let's just do a very simple
program to create this idea for I in
range of four this time because there
are four of these things in the sky
let's go ahead and just print out a
question mark to represent each of those
bricks
odds are you know this is not going to
end well because these are unfortunately
as you predicted on separate lines
so it turns out that the print function
actually takes in multiple arguments not
just the thing you want to print but
also some additional arguments that
allow you to specify what the default
line ending should be but what's
interesting about this is that if you
want to change the line ending to be
something like quote unquote that is
nothing instead of backslash n this is
not sufficient because in Python you can
have two types of arguments or
parameters some arguments are positional
which is the fancy way of saying it's a
comma separated list of arguments and
that's what we did all the time in C
something comma something comes
something we did in printf all the time
and in other functions that took
multiple arguments in Python you have
not only positional arguments where you
just separate them by commas to give one
or two or three or more arguments
they're also named arguments which looks
weird but is helpful for reasons like
this if you read the documentation you
will see that there is a named argument
that python accepts called n and if you
set that equal to something that will be
used as the end of every line instead of
the default which the documentation will
also say is quote unquote backslash n so
this line here has no effect on my logic
at the moment but if I change it to just
quote unquote essentially overriding the
default new line character and now Run
Mario again now I get all four on the
same line there's a bit of a bug though
my prompt is not meant to be on the same
line so I can fix that by just printing
nothing but really it's not nothing
because you get the new line for free so
let me run python of
mario.pi again and now we have what I
intended in the first place which was a
little something that looked like this
and this is just one example of an
argument that has a name but this is a
common Paradigm in Python 2 to not just
separate things by commas but to be very
specific because the print function
might take 5 10 even 20 different
arguments and my God if you had to
enumerate like 10 or 20 commas you're
going to screw up you're going to get
things in the wrong order named
arguments allow you to be resilient
against that so you only specify
arguments by name and it doesn't matter
what order they are in
are any questions then on on this and
the overriding of new line and to be
clear you can do something like very
weird but logically expected like this
by just changing the line ending too but
the right way to solve the Mario problem
would be just to override it to be
nothing like this
all right how about this for cool and
this is why a lot of people like python
suppose you don't really like Loops you
don't really like three line programs
because that was kind of three times
longer than it needs to be what if you
just printed out a question mark four
times
python whoops python of mario.pi that
also works so it turns out that just
like the plus operator in Python can
join things together the multiply
operator is not arithmetic in this case
it actually means take this and do the
concatenate it four times over so that's
a way of just distilling into one line
what would have otherwise taken multiple
lines in C fewer but still multiple
lines in Python but is really now rather
succinct in C in Python by doing that
instead let's do one last Mario example
which looked a little something like
this if this is another part of the
Mario interface this is like a grid of
like three by three bricks for instance
so two Dimensions now just not just
vertical not horizontal but now both
let's print out something like that
using hashes well how about
how do I do this so how about 4i in
range of 3
then I could do for J in range of 3 just
because J comes after I and that's
reasonable for counting I could now
print out a hash symbol
uh well let's see what this does python
of mario.pi okay that's just one crazy
long
column what's what do I need to fix and
where here to make this look like this
so three by three bricks instead of one
long column
any instincts
[Music]
okay so after printing three we want to
skip a line so maybe like print out a
blank line here okay let's try that I
like that instinct right print three new
line print three new line let's go ahead
and run python of mario.pi okay it's
more visible what I'm doing but still
wrong what can I what's the remaining
fix though yeah
[Music]
yeah I'm getting an extra new line here
which I don't want while I'm on this row
so let me do end equals quote unquote
and now together your Solutions might
take us the whole way there Mario uh
pythonfire.pi voila now we've got it in
two dimensions and even this we can
tighten up like we could just use the
little trick we learned so we could just
say print a hash times three times and
we can get rid of one of those Loops
altogether all it's doing is Autumn
whoops all it's doing is automating that
process but no I don't want to do that
what do I how do I fix this here oh I
don't think I want this anymore right
because that's giving me an extra new
line so now this program is really
tightened up same thing two lines of
code but we're now implementing the same
two-dimensional structure here
are any questions here
on these yeah
[Music]
if print n any space say that once more
uh
[Music]
oh
um oh yes good question I see what
you're saying so in a previous version
Let Me rewind in time when we had this I
did not put spaces the convention in
Python is not to do that why it just
starts to add too much space and this is
a little inconsistent because earlier
when we talked about like pluses or
spaces around the less than or equal
signs I did say added here it's actually
clear and recommended to keep them
tighter together otherwise it just
becomes harder to read where the gaps
are good observation all right let's do
how about
um
another five minute break let's do that
and then we're going to dive into some
more sophisticated problems and then
ultimately build with some audio and
visual examples as well see you in five
all right
so almost all of the examples we just
did were Recreations of what we did in
week one and recall that week one was
like our most syntax heavy week it was
when we were first learning how to
program and see but after week one we
began to focus a bit more on ideas like
arrays and other higher level constructs
and we'll do that again here condensing
some of those first early weeks into a
fewer set of examples in Python and
we'll culminate by actually taking
python out for a spin and doing things
that would be way harder to do and way
more time consuming to do and see even
more so than the speller example but how
do you go about figuring out like what
functions exist if you didn't hear it in
class you don't see it online but you
want to see it officially you can go to
the python documentation
docs.python.org here and I will disclaim
that honestly the python documentation
is not terribly user friendly Google
will often be your friend so Googling
something you're interested in to find
your way to the appropriate page on
python.org or stackoverflow.com is
another popular website as always though
the line should be Googling things like
how do I convert a string to lower case
like that's reasonable to Google or how
to convert to uppercase or how Implement
function in Python but Googling of
course things like how to implement
problem set 6 in cs50 of course crosses
the line but moving forward and really
with programming in general like Google
and stack Overflow are your friends but
the line is between the reasonable and
the unreasonable so let me officially
use the python documentation search just
to search for something like the
lowercase function like I know I can
lowercase things in Python I don't quite
remember how so let me just search for
the word lower you're going to get often
an overwhelming number of results
because Python's a pretty big language
with lots of functionality and you're
going to want to look for familiar
patterns for whatever reason string dot
lower which is probably more popular or
more commonly used than these other ones
is third on the list but it's purple
because I clicked it a moment ago when
looking for it so stir dot lower is
probably what I want because I am
interested at the moment in lowercasing
strings when I click on that this is an
example of what Python's documentation
tends to look like it's in this General
format here's my stir dot lower function
this returns a copy of the string with
all the cased characters converted to
lowercase and the lowercasing algorithm
dot dot dot so that doesn't give me much
it doesn't give me sample code but it
does say what the function does and if
we keep looking you'll see mention of L
strip which is left strip I used its
analog R strip before Right strip which
allows you to remove that is stripped
from the end of a string something like
white space like a new line or even
something else and if you scroll through
string this web page here and we're
halfway down the page already if you see
my scroll bar tiny on the right there's
a huge amount of functionality built
into string objects here and this is
just Testament to just how rich the
language itself is but it's also reason
to uh to assure that the goal when
playing around with some new language
and learning it is not to learn it
exhaustively just like in English or any
human language there's always going to
be vocab words you don't know uh ways of
presenting the same information in some
language that's going to be the case
with python and what we'll do today and
this week in problem set 6 is really get
your footing with this language but you
won't know all of python just like you
won't know all of c and honestly you
won't know all of any of these languages
on your own unless you're perhaps using
them full-time professionally and even
then there's more libraries than one
might even retain themselves so let's
actually now pivot to a few other ideas
that we'll Implement in Python in a
moment let me switch back over to vs
code here and let me whip up say a
recreation of our scores example from
week two where we average like three
scores together and that was an
opportunity in week two to play with a
raise to realize how constrained arrays
are they can't grow or Shrink you have
to decide in advance but let's see
what's different here in Python so let
me do scores dot pi
and let me give myself an array in
Python called score sorry let me give
myself a variable in Python called
scores set it equal to a list of three
scores which are the same ones we've
used before 72 73 33 and this context
meant to be scores not ASCII values and
then let's just do the average of these
so average will be another variable and
it turns out I can do
well how did I sum these before I
probably had a for Loop to add one then
I knew how long there were turns out in
Python you can just say sum of scores
divided by the length of scores that's
going to give me my average so sum is a
function that takes a list in this case
as input and it just does the sum for
you with a for Loop or whatever
underneath the hood Lang gives you the
length of the list how many things are
in it so I can dynamically figure that
out now let me go ahead and print out
using print the word average and then in
curly braces the actual average close
quote all right so let's run this code
python of scores dot pi and there's my
average in this case
59.33333 and so forth based on the math
well let's actually now change this a
little bit and make it a little more
interesting and actually get input from
the user rather than hard coding this
let me go back up here and use from cs50
import get in because I don't want to
deal with all the exceptions and the
loops like I just want to use someone
else's function here let me give myself
an empty list called scores and this is
not something we were able to do and see
right because in C if you try to make an
empty array well that's pretty stupid
because you can't add things to it it's
a fixed size so it wouldn't even let you
do that but I can just create an empty
list in Python because lists unlike
arrays are really linked lists they'll
grow and Shrink but you and I are not
dealing with all the pointers underneath
the hood Python's doing that for us so
now let's go ahead and get a whole bunch
of scores from the user I'll have about
three of them in total so four I in
range of three let's go ahead and grab a
score from the user using get int asking
them for score and then let's go ahead
and append to the scores uh list that
particular score so it turns out that a
list and I could read the python
documentation to confirm as much lists
have a function built into them and
functions built into objects are
generally known as methods if you've
heard that term before same idea but
whereas a function kind of stands on its
own a method is a function built into
and object like a list here that's going
to achieve the same result strictly
speaking I don't need the variable just
like in C I could tighten this up and do
something like this as well but I don't
know I kind of like it this way it's
more clear to me at least that what I'm
doing here getting the score and then
appending it to the list now the rest of
the code can stay the same python of
scores.pi score will be 72 73 33 and I
get back the math but now the program's
a little more Dynamic which is nice but
there's other syntax I could use here
just so you've seen it python does have
some neat syntactic tricks whereby if
you don't want to do scores dot append
you can actually say scores plus equals
this score so you can actually
concatenate lists together in Python 2.
just as we use plus to join two strings
together you can use plus to join two
lists together the catch is you need to
put the one score I'm adding here in a
list of its own which is kind of silly
but it's necessary so that this thing
and this thing are both lists to do this
more verbosely which most programmers
wouldn't do but just for clarity this is
the same thing as saying scores plus
this score so now maybe it's a little
more clear that scores and bracket score
plural sorry singular are both lists
themselves being concatenated or joined
together so two different ways not sure
one is better than the other this way is
pretty common but dot append is also
quite reasonable as well
all right how about another example from
week two uh this one was called uh
uppercase so let me do this in uppercase
dot Pi though this time and let me
import from cs50 getstring again
and let me go ahead and say before will
be my first variable let me get a string
from the user asking them for a before
string and then let me go ahead and say
after just to demonstrate some changes
upper casing to this string uh let me
change my line ending to be that using
our new trick and this is where things
get cool in Python relatively speaking
if I want to iterate over all of the
characters in a string and print them
out in uppercase one way to do that
would be this 4 C in the before string
go ahead and print out C dot uppercase
sorry C Dot Upper but don't end the line
yet because I want to keep these all on
the same line until I'm all done so what
am I doing python of uppercase.pi let me
type in hello and I'll lower case I've
just uppercased the whole string how I
first get string calling it before I
then just print out some fluffy text
that says after colon and I get rid of
the line ending just so I can kind of
line these up notice I hit the space bar
a couple times just so letters line up
to be pretty 4C and before this is is
new this is powerful in C I'm sorry in
Python whereby you don't have to do like
in I equals zero and I less than this
you could just say for C in the string
in question for C and before and then
here is just uppercasing that specific
character and making sure we don't
output a new line too soon but this is
actually more work than I need to do
based on what we've seen thus far like
from our agreement example can I tighten
this up further can I Collapse lines
five and six maybe even seven all
together if I the goal of this program
is just to uppercase
the before string
how might I do this
yeah and back
[Music]
stir Dot Upper yeah so I could do
something like this after it gets before
Dot Upper so it's not stir literally Dot
Upper stir just represents the string in
question so it would be before Dot Upper
but right idea otherwise and so let me
go ahead and just tweak my print
statement a little bit let me just go
ahead and print out the after variable
here after creating it so this line is
the same I'm getting a string called
before I'm creating another variable
called after and as you propose I'm
calling upper on the whole string not
one character at a time why because it's
allowed and again in Python there aren't
technically characters individually
there's only strings anyway so I might
as well do them all at once so if I
rerun the code now python of
uppercase.pi now I'll type in hello in
all lowercase and oh so close I think I
can get rid of this override because I'm
printing the whole thing out at once not
character by character so now if I type
in hello before now I have an even
tighter version of the program here
all right any questions then on lists or
on strings
and what this kind of function upper
represents with its Docs
[Music]
all right so a couple other building
blocks before we start oh
where was that
to the right the right right yes thank
you
[Music]
yes do I have to create this variable
upper no I don't I could actually
tighten this up and if you really want
to see something neat inside of the
curly braces you don't have to just put
the names of variables you can put a
small amount of logic so long as it
doesn't start to look stupid and kind of
overwhelmingly complex such that it's
sort of bad design at that point I can
tighten this up like this and now run
python of uppercase dot Pi writing hello
again and that too worked but I would be
careful about this you want to resist
the temptation of having like a long
line of code that's inside the curly
braces because it's just going to be
harder to read but absolutely you could
indeed do that too all right how about
uh command line arguments which is one
thing we introduced in week two also so
that we could actually have the ability
to take input from the user whoops so we
could actually take input from the user
at the command line so as to take
literally command line arguments these
are a little different but it follows
the same Paradigm there's no no main by
default and there's no def main int rxc
Char or we called it string ARG V by
default there's none of this so if you
want access to the argument Vector ARG V
you import it and it turns out there's
another module in python or library in
Python called sys and you can import
from the system this thing called ARG V
so same idea different place now I'm
going to go ahead and do this let's
write a program that just requires that
the user types in two a word after the
program's name or none at all so if the
length of ARG V equals two let's go
ahead and print out how about hello
comma ARG V bracket one
close quote else if they don't type two
words total at the prompt let's just say
the default like we did weeks ago hello
world so the only thing that's new here
is we're importing RGB from sys and
we're using this fancy F string format
which kind of to your point too it's
it's putting more complex logic in the
curly braces but that's okay this in
this case it's a list called ARG V and
we're getting bracket one from it let's
do python of arcv dot Pi enter hello
world what if I do ARG V Dot Pi David at
the command line now I get hello David
so there's one curiosity here python is
not included in ARG V whereas in C dot
slash whatever was the first thing if
the analog in Python is that the name of
your Python program is the first thing
in bracket zero which is why David is in
bracket one the word python does not
appear in the ARG V list just to be
clear but otherwise the idea of these
arguments is exactly the same as before
and in fact what you can do which is
kind of cool is because arcv is a list
you can do things like this for ARG in
ARG V go ahead and print out each
argument so instead of using a for Loop
an i and all of this if I do python of
ARG V enter it just writes the program's
name if I do python of argv Foo it puts
arguv dot pi and Foo if I do sorry if I
do Foo and bar those words all print out
if I do foobar baz those print out too
and Foo and borrower baz are like a
mathematicians X and Y and Z for a
computer scientists when you just need
some placeholder words so this is just
nice it reads a little more like English
and a for Loop is just much more concise
allows you to iterate very quickly when
you want something like that suppose I
only wanted the real words that the
human typed after the program's name
like suppose I want to ignore
argv.pi I mean I could do something
hackish like this if ARG equals argv dot
Pi I could just ignore you know let's
invert the logic I could do this for
instance so if the ARG does not equal
the program name then go ahead and print
out the word so I get Fubar and baz only
or this is what's kind of neat about
python 2. let me undo that and let me
just take a slice of the array of the
list instead so it turns out if argue is
a list I can actually say you know what
go into that list start at element one
instead of zero and then go all the way
to the end and we have not seen the
syntax in C but this is a way of slicing
a list in Python so now watch what
happens if I run python of RV dot Pi Foo
bar baz enter I get only a subset of the
list starting at position one going all
the way to the end and you can even do
kind of the opposite if for whatever
reason you want to ignore the last
element you can say colon
we could say colon negative one and use
a negative number which we've not seen
before which slices off the end of the
list as well so there's some syntactic
tricks that tend to be powerful in
Python 2 even if at first glance you
might not need them for typical things
all right let's do one other example
with exit and then we'll start actually
applying some algorithms to make things
interesting so in one last program here
let's do exit dot Pi just to do one more
mechanic before we introduce some
algorithms and
let's do this let's import
um from sys import ARG V Let's now do
this let's make sure the user gives me
one command line argument so if the
length of ARG V does not equal 2 in
total then let's go ahead and print out
something like missing command line
argument just to explain what the
problem is and then let's do this we can
exit but I'm going to use a better
version of exit here let me import two
functions from sys turns out the better
way to do this is with sys.exit because
I can then exit specifically to with
this exit code otherwise down here I'm
going to go ahead and print out
something like uh hello comma RV bracket
one same as before and then I'm going to
exit with zero so again this was a
subtle thing we introduced in week two
where you can actually have your
programs exit with some number where
zero signifies success and anything else
signifies error this is just the same
idea in Python so if I for instance just
run the program like this oops I screwed
up I meant to say exit here and exit
here let me do that again if I run this
like this I'm missing a command line
argument so let me rerun it with like my
name at the prompt so I have exactly two
command line arguments the file name and
my name hello comma David and if I do
David Malin it's not going to work
either because now ARG V does not equal
two but the difference here is that
we're exiting with one so that special
programs can detect an error or zero in
the event of success and now there's one
other way to do this too suppose that
you're importing a lot of functions and
you don't really want to make a mess of
things and just have all of these
function names available without it
being clear where they came from let's
just import all of CIS and let's just
change our syntax kind of like I
proposed for cs50 where we just prepend
to all of these Library functions CIS
just to be super explicit where they
came from and if there's another uh exit
or arc V value that we want to import
from a library this is one way to avoid
Collision so if I do it one last time
here here missing command line argument
but David still actually works all right
only to demonstrate how we can Implement
that same idea let's now do something
more powerful like a search algorithm
like binary search I'm going to go ahead
and open up a file called numbers.pi and
let's just do some searching or linear
search rather on a list of numbers
let's go ahead and do this how about
import sys as before let me give myself
a list of numbers like four six eight
two seven five zero so just a bunch of
integers and then let's do this if you
recall from week three we searched for
the number zero at the end of the
lockers on stage so let's just ask that
question in Python no need for a loop or
anything like that if 0 is in the
numbers go ahead and print out found and
then let's just exit successfully with
zero else if we get down here let's just
say print not found and then we'll
assist then we'll assist exit with one
so this is where python starts to get
powerful again here's your list here is
your Loop that's doing all of the
checking for you underneath the hood
python is going to use linear search you
don't have to implement it yourself no
while loop no for Loop you just ask a
question if zero is in numbers then do
the following so that's one feature we
now get with python and get to throw
away a lot of that code we can do it
with strings too let me open in a file
called names.pi instead and do something
that was even more involved in C because
we needed stir comp and the for Loop and
so forth let me import CIS for this file
let's give myself a bunch of names like
we did in C and those were Bill and
Charlie and Fred and George and Ginny
and two more uh Percy and lastly Ron and
recall at the time we looked for Ron and
so we had to iterate through the whole
thing doing stir comp and I plus plus
and all of that now just ask the
question if Ron is uh in names then
let's go ahead and whoops let me hide
that I hit the command too soon let me
go ahead and say print uh found as
before sys Exit 1 just to indicate
success and then down here if we get to
this point we can say not found and then
we'll just sys exit one instead so again
this just does linear search for us by
default python of names.pi we found Ron
because indeed he's there and at the end
of the list but we don't need to deal
with all of the mechanics of it all
right let's take things one step further
in week three we also implemented the
idea of a phone book that actually
Associated keys with values but remember
the phone book in C was kind of a hack
right because we first had two arrays
one with names one with numbers then we
introduced structs and so we gave you a
person structure and then we had array
of we had an array of persons you can do
this in Python using objects and things
called classes but we can also just use
a general purpose dictionary because
just like in P said five you can
associate keys with values using a hash
table using a try will similarly can
python just do this for us from cs50
let's import get string and now let's
give myself a dictionary of people dict
open print close print gives you a
dictionary or you can simplify the
syntax actually and a dictionary again
is just keys and values words and
definitions you can also just use curly
braces instead that gives me an empty
dictionary but if I know what I want to
put in it by default let's put Carter in
there with a number of plus one six one
seven four nine five one thousand just
like last time and put myself David with
plus one nine four nine four six eight
2750 and it came to my attention
tragically after class that day that we
had a bug in our little Easter egg if
today you would like to call me or text
me at that number we have fixed the code
that underlies that little Easter egg
spoiler ahead all right so this now
gives me a variable called people that's
associating keys with values there is
some new syntax here in Python not just
the curly braces but the colons and the
quotes on the left and the right this is
a way in Python of associating keys with
values words with definitions anything
with anything else and it's going to be
a super common Paradigm including in
week seven when we look at CSS and HTML
and web programming keys and values are
like this omnipresent idea in computer
science and programming because it's
just a really useful way of associating
one thing with another so at this point
in the story we have a dictionary a hash
table if you will of people associating
names with phone numbers just like a
real world phone book let's write a
program that gets a string from the user
and asks them whose number they would
like to look up
then let's go ahead and say if that name
is in the people dictionary go ahead and
print out that person's number by going
into the people dictionary and going to
that specific name within there using an
F string for the whole thing so this is
similar to in spirit to before linear
search and Dictionary lookups will just
happen automatically for you in Python
by just asking the question if name and
people and this Line's just going to
print out whoever is in the people
dictionary at that name so I'm using
square brackets because here's the
interesting thing in Python just like
you can index into an array or a list in
Python using numbers 0 1 2 you can very
conveniently index into a dictionary in
Python using square brackets as well and
just to make clear what's going on here
let me go and create a temporary
variable person equals people bracket
name and then let's just or sorry let's
say number equals people bracket name
and they'll just print out the number in
question
in C and previously in Python anything
with square brackets like this would
have been go to a location in a list or
an array using a number but that can
actually be a string like a word the
human is typed and this is what's
amazing about dictionaries it's not like
a big line of a big linear thing it's
this table that you can look up in one
column the name and get back in the
other column the number so let's go
ahead and run python of phonebook.pi
found not that oh wait uh
that's not what's supposed to happen at
all
I think I'm in the wrong place
what's going on
print found
I am confused okay
let's run this again pythonophonebook.pi
what the
[Music]
okay stand by
uh-huh
[Music]
foreign
what am I not understanding here
[Music]
okay wrong Shin Carter do you see what
I'm doing wrong
[Music]
what the
say again
[Music]
oh what yeah uh I found okay we're gonna
do this one sec
[Music]
whoa okay
um all this is coming out of the video
um so
thanks
all right I will try to figure out what
was going wrong the best I can tell it
was running the wrong program I don't
quite understand why so we will diagnose
this later I just put the file into a
temporary directory for now to run it so
let me go ahead and just run this python
of phonebook.pi type in for instance my
name and there's my corresponding number
I have no idea what was just happening
but I will get to the bottom of it and
update you if we can put our finger on
it so this was just an example now of
implementing a phone book Let's now
consider what we can do that's a little
more powerful in these examples like a
phone book that actually keeps this
information around thus far these simple
phone book examples throw the
information away but using CSV files
comma separated values maybe we could
actually keep around the names and
numbers so that like on your phone you
can actually keep your contacts around
long term so I'm going to go ahead now
and do a slightly different example and
let me just hide this detail so it's not
confusing whoops I'm going to change my
prompt temporarily so let me go ahead
now and refine this example as follows
I'm going to go into
phonebook.pi and I'm going to import a
whole Library called CSV and this is a
powerful one because python comes with a
library that just handles CSV files for
you a CSV file is just a file with comma
separated values and in fact to
demonstrate this let me check on one
thing here just to make this a little
more real to demonstrate this let's go
ahead and do this let me import the CSV
library from cs50 let me import get
string let me then open a file using the
open function open a file called
phonebook.csv in append format in
contrast with read format and write
format right just blows it away if it
exists append adds to the bottom of it
so I keep this phone book around just
like you might keep adding contacts to
your phone now let me go ahead and get a
couple values from the user let me say
get string and ask the user for a name
then let me get get string again
and ask the user for their number and
now let me go ahead and do this and this
is new and this is python specific and
you would only know this by following a
tutorial or reading the documentation
let me give myself a variable called
writer and ask the CSV library for a
writer to that file
then let me go ahead and use that writer
variable use a function or a method
inside of it called right row to write
out a list containing that person's name
and number notice the square brackets
inside the parentheses because I'm just
printing a list to that particular Row
in the file and then I'm just going to
close the file so what is the effect of
all of this well let me go ahead and run
this version of phonebook.pi and I'm
prompted for a name let's do Carter's
first plus one six one seven four four
nine five
one thousand
and then let's go ahead and LS notice in
my current directory there's two files
now phonebook.pi which I wrote and
apparently
phonebook.csv CSV just stands for comma
separated values and it's like a very
simple way of storing data in a
spreadsheet if you will where the comma
represents the separation between your
columns there's only two columns here
name and number but because I'm writing
to this file in append mode let me run
it one more time python of phonebook.pi
and let me go ahead and do David and
plus one
949-468-2750 enter and notice what
happened in the CSV file it
automatically updated because I'm now
persisting this data to the file in
question so if I wanted to Now read this
file in I could actually go ahead and do
linear search on the data using a read
function to actually read from the CSV
but for now we'll just leave it a little
simply as right and let me make one
refinement here it turns out that if
you're in the habit of re opening a file
you don't have to even close it
explicitly you can instead do this you
can instead say with the opening of a
file called phonebook.csv in append mode
calling the thing file go ahead and do
all of these lines here so the with
keyword is a new thing in Python and
it's used in a few different ways but
one of the ways it's used is to tighten
up code here and I'm going to move my
variables to the outside because they
don't need to be inside of the width
statement where the file is open this
just has the effect ensuring that you
the programmer don't screw up and
accidentally Don't Close Your file in
fact you might recall from C valgren
might have complained at you if you had
a file that you didn't close a file you
might have had a memory leak as a result
the width keyword takes care of all of
that for you as well
let me go ahead and propose that on your
phone or laptop here or online go to
this URL here where you'll find a Google
form and just to show that these csvs
are actually kind of omnipresent and if
you've ever like used a Google form or
manage a student group or something
where you've collected data via Google
forms you can actually export all of
that data via CSV files so go ahead to
this URL here
and those of you watching on demand
later will find that the form is no
longer working since we're only doing
this live but that will lead to a Google
form that's going to let everyone input
their answer to a question like what
house do you want to end up into sort of
an approximation of the Sorting Hat in
Harry Potter and Via this form will we
then have the ability to export we'll
see a CSV file
so let's give you a moment to do that
in just a moment I'll share my version
of the screen which is going to let me
actually open the file the form itself
and in just a moment I'll switch over
okay so this is now my version of the
form here where we have 200 plus
responses to a simple question of the
form what house do you belong in
Gryffindor Hufflepuff Ravenclaw or
Slytherin if I go over to responses I'll
see all of the responses in the GUI form
here so graphical user interface and we
could flip through this and it looks
like uh interestingly 40 of Harvard
students want to be in Gryffindor
um 22 in Slytherin and everyone else in
between the others but you might have
noticed if ever using a Google form this
Google spreadsheet slang so I'm going to
go ahead and click that and that's going
to automatically open in this case
Google spreadsheets but you can say you
do the same thing with Office 365 as
well and now you see the raw data as a
spreadsheet but in Google spreadsheets
if I go to file and then I go to
download notice I can download this as
an Excel file a PDF and also a CSV comma
separated values so let me go ahead and
do that that gives me a file in my
downloads folder on my computer I'm
going to now go back to my code editor
here and what I'm going to go and ahead
and do is upload this file from my
downloads folder to vs code so that we
can actually see it within here and now
you can see this open file and I'm going
to shorten its name just so it's a
little easier to read I'm going to
rename this using the MV command to just
hogwarts.csv and then we can see in the
file that there's two columns timestamp
column house where you have a whole
bunch of time stamps when people filled
out the form with someone very early in
class and then everyone else just a
moment ago and the second value after
each comma is the name of the house well
let me go ahead here and Implement a
program in a file called Hogwarts dot Pi
that processes this data so in
hogwarts.pi let's just wear at a program
that now reads a CSV in this case not a
phone book but everyone's Sorting Hat
information and I'm going to go ahead
and import CSV and suppose I want to
answer a reasonable question ignoring
the fact that Google's GUI or graphical
user interface can do this for me I just
want to count up who's going to be in
which house so let me give myself a
dictionary called houses that's in
initially empty with curly braces and
let me pre-create a few keys let me say
Griff indoor is going to be initialized
to zero Hufflepuff will be initialized
to zero as well Ravenclaw will be
initialized to zero and finally
Slytherin will be initialized to zero so
here's another example of a dictionary
or a hash table just being a very
general purpose piece of data you can
have keys and values the keys in this
case are the houses the values are
initially zero but I'm going to use this
instead of like four separate variables
to keep track of everyone's answer to
this form so I'm going to do this with
opening Hogwarts dot CSV in read mode
not append I don't want to change it I
just want to read it as file as my
variable name let's go ahead and create
a reader this time
that is using the reader function in the
CSV Library by opening that file I'm
going to go ahead and ignore the first
line of the file because recall that the
first line is just time stamp and house
I want to get the real data so this next
function is just a little trick for
ignoring the first file the first line
of the file then let's do this for every
other Row in the reader that is line by
line get the current person's house
which is in Row Bracket one this is what
the CSV Reader Library is doing for us
it's handling all of the reading of this
file it figures out where the comma is
and for every Row in the file it hands
you back a list of size 2 in bracket
zero is the timestamp and bracket one is
the house name so in my code I can say
house equals Row Bracket one I don't
care about the timestamp for this
program and then let's go into my
dictionary called houses plural index
into it at the house location by its
name and increment that zero to one
and now at the end of this block of code
that has the effect of iterating over
every line in the file updating my
dictionary in four different places
based on whether someone typed
Gryffindor or uh Slytherin or anything
else and notice that I'm using the name
of the house to index into my dictionary
to essentially go up to this little
cheat sheet and change the zero to a one
the one to a two the two to a three
instead of having like four separate
variables which would be just be much
more annoying to maintain down at the
bottom let's just print out the results
for each house in those houses iterating
over the keys therein by default in
Python let's go ahead and print out an F
string that says the current house has
the current uh count and count will be
the result of indexing into houses for
that given house and let me close my
quote
so let's run this to summarize the data
Hogwarts dot Pi 140 of you answered
Gryffindor 54 Hufflepuff 72 Ravenclaw
and 80 of you Slytherin and that's just
my now way of code and this is oh my God
so much easier than C to actually
analyze data in this way and one of the
reasons that Python's so popular for
data science and analytics more
generally is that it's actually really
easy to manipulate data and run
analytics like this and let me clean
this up slightly it's a little Annoying
that I just have to know and trust that
the house name is in bracket zero
bracket one and timestamp is in bracket
zero let's clean this up there's
something called a dictionary reader in
the CSV library that I can use instead
capital D capital r this means I can
throw away this next thing because what
a dictionary reader does is it still
returns to me every Row from the file
one after the other but it doesn't just
give me a list of size 2 representing
each row it gives me a dictionary and it
uses as the keys in that dictionary
array time stamp and house for every Row
in the file which is just to say it
makes my code a little more readable
because instead of doing this little
trickery bracket one I can say quote
unquote bracket house with a capital H
because it's capitalized in the Google
form itself so the code now is just
minorly different but it's way more
resilient especially if I'm using Google
spreadsheets and I'm moving the columns
around or doing something like that
where the numbers might get messed up
now I can run this on hogwarts.pi again
and I get the same answers but I now
don't have to worry about where those
individual columns are
all right any questions on those
capabilities there
it's a teaser of sorts for what some of
the manipulation we'll do in pset six
all right so some final examples and
Flair to Intrigue with what you can do
with python I'm going to actually switch
over to a terminal window on my own Mac
so that I can actually use audio a
little more effectively so here's just a
terminal window on Mac OS I before class
have pre-installed some additional
python libraries that won't really work
in vs code in the cloud because they
require audio that the browser won't
necessarily support but I'm going to go
ahead and write an example here that
involves writing a speech-based program
that actually does something with speech
and I'm going to go ahead and import a
library that again I pre-installed
called python text to speech and I'm
going to go ahead and per its
documentation give myself a speech
engine by using that libraries init
function for initialize I'm then going
to use this engine's save function to do
something fun like hello world and then
I'm going to go ahead and tell this
engine to run and wait while it says
those words all right I'm going to save
this file I'm not using vs code at the
moment I'm using another popular program
that we used in cs50 back in Day called
Vim which is a command line program
that's just in this black and white
window let me go ahead now and run
python of speech.pi and
hello world
all right so it's a little computerized
but it is speech that has been
synthesized from this example let's
change it a little bit to be more
interesting let's do something like this
let's ask the user for their name like
what's your name question mark and then
let's use a little F string and say not
hello world but hello to that person's
name let me save my file run
pythonofspeech.pi enter
David hello David all right so we
pronounce my name okay might struggle
with different names depending on the
phonetics but that one seemed to be okay
let's do something else with python
using similarly just a few lines of code
uh let me go into
uh today's examples and I'm going to go
into a folder called detect whoops a
folder called faces dot Pi sorry faces
and in this folder that I've written in
advance or a few files detect dot pi
recognize.pi and two full of photos
office.jpg and toby.jpg if you're
familiar with the show here for instance
is the cast photo from the office here
so here's a photo as input suppose I
want to do something very Facebook style
where I want to analyze all of the faces
or find detect all of the faces in there
well let me go ahead and show you a
program I wrote in advance
that's not terribly long much of it is
actually comments but let's see what I'm
doing I'm importing the pillow Library
again to get access to images I'm
importing a library called face
recognition which I downloaded and
installed in advance but it does what it
says according to its documentation you
go into that library and you call a
function called load image file to load
something like office.jpg and then you
can use a line of code like this call a
function called face locations passing
the images input and you get back a list
of all of the faces in the image and
then down here a for Loop that iterates
over all of those face locations and
inside of this loop I just do a bit of
trickery I figure out the top right
bottom and left corners of those
locations and then using these lines of
code here I'm using that image library
to just draw a box essentially and the
code looks cryptic honestly I would have
to look this up to write it again but
per the documentation this just draws a
nice little box around the image so let
me go ahead and zoom out here and run
this now on office.jpg
all right
it's analyzing analyzing and you can see
in the sidebar here here's the original
and here is every face that my what 10
lines of python code found within that
file what's a face presumably the
library is looking for something maybe
without a mask that has two eyes a nose
and a mouth and some kind of arrangement
some kind of pattern so it would seem
pretty reliable at least on these fairly
easy to read faces here what if we want
to look for someone specific for
instance someone that's always getting
picked on well we could do something
like this recognize.pi which is taking
two files as input that image and the
image of one person in particular and if
you're trying to find Toby in a crowd
here I conflated the program sorry this
is the version that draws a box around
the given face here we have Toby as
identified why because that program
recognized.pi has a few more lines of
code but long story short it
additionally loads as input
toby.jpg in order to recognize that
specific face and that specific face is
a completely different photo but it
looks similar and enough to the person
that it all worked out okay let's do one
other that's a little sensitive to
microphones let me go into
um how about my listen folder here which
is available online too and let's just
run python of listen zero dot Pi I'm
going to type in like David
oh sorry no I'm gonna
[Music]
hello world
oh no that's the wrong version okay I
look like an idiot okay hello there we
go hello to you too and if I say goodbye
I'm talking to my laptop like an idiot
okay
now it's detecting what I'm saying here
so this first version of the program is
just using some relatively simple if L
if L if and it's just asking for input
forcing it to lower case and that was my
mistake with the first example and then
I'm just checking is hello in the user's
words is how are you in the user's words
didn't see that but it's there is
goodbye in the user's words now let's do
a cooler version using a library just by
looking at the effect python of listen
one dot pi
hello world
[Music]
huh let's do version two of this that
uses a audio a speech to text Library
hello world
okay so now it's artificial intelligence
now let's do something a little more
interesting the third version of this
program that actually analyzes the words
that are said
hello world my name is David how are you
[Music]
okay so that time it not only analyzed
what I said but it plucked my name out
of it let's do two final examples this
one will generate a QR code let me go
ahead and write a program called qr.i
that very simply does this let me import
a library called OS let me import a
library called QR code let me grab an
image here that's QR code.make and let
me give you like the URL of like a
lecture video on YouTube or something
like that with this ID
let me just type this so I don't get it
wrong
okay so if I now use this URL here of a
video on YouTube making sure I haven't
made any typos I'm now going to go ahead
and do two lines of code in Python I'm
going to first save that as a file
called qr.png which is a two dimensional
barcode or QR code and indeed I'm going
to use this format and I'm going to use
the OS dot system library to open qr.png
automatically and if you'd like to take
out your phone at this point you can see
the result of my barcode that's just
been dynamically generated
hopefully from afar that will scan
[Music]
I think that's an appropriate line to
line take it for cs50 we will see you
next time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and this is week seven the week here of
Halloween indeed special thanks to
cs50's own Valerie and her mom for
having created this very festive scenery
and all past ones as well today we pick
up where we left off last time which
recall we introduced Python and that was
our big transition from C where suddenly
things started to look new again
probably syntactically but also probably
things hopefully started to feel easier
well with that said like problem sets
certainly added some challenges and you
did some new things but hopefully you'll
be if you're going to appreciate that
with python just a lot more stuff is
easier to do you get more out of the box
with the language itself and that's
going to be so useful over the coming
weeks as we transition further to
introducing something called databases
today uh web programming next week and
the week after so that by terms end and
perhaps even for your final project you
really are building something from
scratch using all of these various tools
somehow together so before we do that
though today let's consider what we
weren't really able to do last week
which was actually create and store data
ourselves right in Python we've played
around with the CSV comma separated
values library and you've been able to
read in csvs from disk so to speak that
is from files in your programming
environment but we haven't necessarily
started saving data persisting data
ourselves and that's a huge limitation
because pretty much all of the examples
we've done thus far with a couple of
exceptions have involved my providing
input at the keyboard or even vocally
but then nothing happens to it it
disappears The Moment the program quits
because it was only being stored in
memory but today we'll start to focus
all the more on storing things on disk
that is storing things in files and
folders so that you can actually write
programs that remember what it is the
human did last time and ultimately you
can actually make mobile or web apps
that actually begin to grow and grow and
grow their data sets as might happen if
you get more and more users for instance
on a website to play then with this new
capability of being able to write files
let's go ahead and just collect some
data in fact those of you here in person
if you want to pull up this URL on your
phone or laptop that's going to lead you
to a Google form and that Google form is
going to ask you
in just a moment for really just your
favorite TV show and it's going to ask
you to categorize it according to a
genre like comedy or drama or action or
musical or something like that and this
is useful because if you've ever used a
Google form before or Microsoft's
equivalent with Office 365 it's a really
useful mechanism of just collecting data
from users and then ultimately putting
it into a spreadsheet form so this is a
screenshot of the form that those of you
here in person are tuning in on Zoom are
currently filling out it's asking only
two questions What's the title of your
favorite TV show and what are one or
more genres into which your TV show
Falls and I'll go ahead and pivot now to
the view that I'll be able to see as the
person who created this form which is
quite simply a Google spreadsheet Google
forms has this nice feature if you've
ever noticed that allows you to export
your data to a Google spreadsheet and
then from there we can actually grab the
file and download it to my own Mac or
your own PC so that we can actually play
around with the data that's come in so
in fact let me go ahead and slide over
to this the live Google spreadsheet and
you'll see probably a whole bunch of
familiar TV shows here all coming in and
if we keep scrolling and scrolling and
scrolling only 46 47 there we go up to
50 plus already if you need that URL
again here if you're just tuning in you
can go to this URL here
and in just a moment we'll have a bunch
of data with which we can start to
experiment I'll give you a moment or so
there
[Music]
all right
let me hang in there a little longer
okay we've got over 100 submissions good
good even more coming in now
and we can see them coming in live here
let me switch back to the spreadsheet
the list is growing and growing and
growing and in just a moment let me give
Carter a moment to help me export it in
real time Carter just give me a heads up
when it's reasonable for me to download
this file
all right and I'll begin to do this very
slowly so I'm going to go up to the file
menu if you've never done this before
download you can download a whole bunch
of formats one in Excel but more simply
and the one we'll start to play with
here is comma separated values so CSV
files we use this past week why are they
useful now that you've played with them
or used them in past real world like
what's the utility of a CSV file versus
something like Excel for instance
why CSV in the first place
any instincts yeah
okay so storage is compelling a simple
text file with ASCII or Unicode text is
probably pretty small I like that other
thoughts
yeah well said it's just a simple text
format but using conventions like commas
you can represent the idea of columns
using new lines backslash ends invisibly
at the end of your lines you can create
the idea of rows so it's a very simple
way of implementing what we might call a
flat file database it's a way of storing
data in a flat that is very simple file
that's just pure ASCII or Unicode text
and more compellingly I dare say is that
with a CSV file it's completely portable
something's portable in the world of
computing if it means you can use it on
a Mac or a PC running this operating
system or this other one and portability
is nice because if I were to download an
Excel file there'd be a whole bunch of
people in this room and online who
couldn't download it because they
haven't bought Microsoft Excel or
installed it or if they have a Mac they
might not or if it's a DOT numbers file
in the Mac World a PC user might not be
able to download it so a CSV is indeed
very portable so I'm going to go ahead
and download quite simply the CSV
version of this file that's going to put
it onto my own Max downloads folder and
let me go ahead here and in just a
moment let me just simplify the name
because it actually downloads it at a
pretty small a pretty large name and
give me just one moment here and you'll
see that indeed on my Mac I have a file
called
favorites.csv I shorten the name real
quick and now what I'm going to do is go
over to vs code and in vs code I'm going
to open my File Explorer and if I
minimize my window here for a moment
it's a handy feature of vs code is that
you can just drag and drop a file for
instance into your Explorer and voila
it's going to automatically upload it
for you so let me go ahead in full
screen here close my Explorer
temporarily close my terminal window and
you'll see here a CSV file favorites.csv
and the first row by convention has
whatever the columns were in Google
spreadsheets or Office 365 in Excel
online timestamp comma title comma
genres then we have timestamps which
indicates when people started submitting
looks like a couple of people were super
eager to get started an hour or two ago
and then you have the title next after a
comma but there's kind of a curiosity
after that sometimes I see the genre
like comedy comedy comedy but sometimes
it's like crime comma drama or action
comma crime comma drama and those things
are quoted and yet I didn't do any
quotes you probably didn't type any
quotes where are those quotes coming
from in the CSV file
why are they there if we infer yeah
[Music]
yeah so you have a kind of a corner case
if you will because if you're using
commas as you describe to separate your
data into what are effectively columns
well you've kind of painted yourself
into a corner if your actual data has
commas in itself so what Google has done
what Microsoft does what Apple does is
they quote any strings of text that
themselves have commas so that these are
now sort of English grammatical commas
not CSV specific commas so it's a way of
escaping your data if you will and
escaping just means to call out a symbol
in a special way so it's not
misinterpreted as something else all
right so this is all to say that we now
have all of this data with which we can
play in the form of what we'll start
calling a flat file database so suppose
I wanted to now start manipulating this
data and I want to store It ultimately
indeed in this CSV format how can I
actually start to read this data Maybe
clean it up maybe do some analytics on
it and actually figure out what's the
most popular show among those who
submitted here over the past few minutes
well let me go ahead and close this let
me go ahead then and open up for
instance just my terminal window and
let's code up a file called favorites
dot pi and let's go ahead and
iteratively start simple by just opening
up this file and printing out what's
inside of it so you might recall that we
can do this by doing something like
import CSV to give myself some CSV
reading functionality then I can go
ahead and do something like with open
the name of the file that I want to open
in read mode quote and quote R means to
read it and then I can say as file or
whatever other name for a variable to
say that I want to open this file and
essentially store some kind of reference
to it in that variable called file then
I can give myself a reader and I can say
csv.reader passing in that file is input
and this is the magic of that Library it
deals with the process of opening it
reading it and giving you back something
that you can just iterate over like with
a for loop I do want to skip the first
row and recall that I can do this next
reader is this little trick that just
says ignore the first row because the
first one special it said time stamp
title genres that's not your data that
was mine but this means now that I've
skipped that first row everything
Hereafter is going to be the title of a
show that you all like so let me do this
for Row in the reader let's go ahead and
print out the title of the show each of
you typed in how do I get at the title
of the show each of you typed in it's
somewhere inside of row row recalls a
list so what do I want to type next in
order to get at the title of the current
row
just as a quick check here
what I want to type to get at the title
of the row keeping in mind again that it
was timestamp
title genres yeah
so Row Bracket one would give me the
second column zero index that is the one
in the Middle with the title so this
program isn't that interesting yet but
it's a quick and dirty way to figure out
all right what's my day to look like let
me actually just do a little bit of a
check here and see if it contains the
data I think it does let me maximize my
terminal window here let me run python
of favorites.pi hitting enter and you'll
see now a purely textual list of all of
the shows you all seem to like here
but what's no worthy about it specific
shows aside judgment aside as to
people's TV tastes like what's
interesting or noteworthy about the data
that might create some problems for us
if we start to analyze this data and
figure out what's the most popular how
many people like this or that
[Music]
what do you think yeah
yeah there might be user errors or just
sort of stylistic differences that give
the appearance that one show is
different from the other for instance
here let's see if I can see an example
on the screen here yeah so friends here
is an all lower case friends here is
capitalized no no big deal we can sort
of mitigate that but this is just a tiny
example of where data in the real world
can get messy fast and that probably
wasn't even a typo it was just sort of
just someone not carrying as much to
capitalize it and that's fine your users
are going to type what they're going to
type so let's see if we can't now begin
to get at more specific data and maybe
even clean some of this data up let me
go back into my uh file called
favorites.pa here and let's actually do
something a little more user friendly
for me instead of a reader recall that
there was this dictionary reader that's
just a little more user friendly and it
means I can type in dictionary reader
here passing in the same file but now
when I iterate over this reader variable
what is each row when using a dict
reader instead of a reader recall and
this is just a particular peculiarity of
the CSV Library this gives me back not a
list of cells but what instead
which is marginally more user-friendly
for me yeah
yeah I can now use Open Bracket quotes
and the title because what's coming back
now is a dict object that is a
dictionary which has keys and values the
keys of which are the column headings
the values of which are the data I
actually care about so this is just
marginally better because one it's just
way more obvious to me the author of
this code what it is I'm getting at I
mean I don't remember what column the
title was was it zero was it one was it
two that's something you're going to
forget over time and God forbid someone
changes the data by just dragging and
dropping the columns in Excel or apple
numbers or Google spreadsheets that's
going to break all of your numeric
indices and so a dictionary reader is
arguably just better design because it's
more robust against changes and
potential errors like that now the
effect of this program of this change
isn't going to be really any different
if I run python of favorites.pi voila I
get all of the same results but I've now
not made any assumptions as to where
each of the columns actually is
numerically all right well let's go
ahead and now filter out some duplicates
because there's a lot of commonality I'm
on some of the shows here so let's see
if we can't filter out duplicates
if I'm reading a CSV file top to bottom
what intuitively might be the like logic
I want to implement to filter out
duplicates
it's not going to be quite as simple as
a simple function that does it for me
I'm going to have to build this
but logically if you're reading a file
from top to bottom how might you go
about in python or just any context
getting rid of duplicate values
yeah what do you think
[Music]
sure I could use a list and I could add
each title to the list but first check
if I've put this into the list before so
let's try a little something like that
let me go ahead and create a a variable
at the top of my program here I'll call
it titles for instance initialize to an
empty list Open Bracket close bracket
and then inside of my Loop here instead
of printing it out let's start to make a
decision so if the current rows title uh
uh is in the titles array I don't want
to the title is list I don't want to put
it there and actually let me invert the
logic so I'm doing something proactively
so if it's not the case that row dot Row
Bracket title is in titles then go ahead
and do something like titles dot uh
append the current rows title and recall
that we saw dot append uh a week or so
ago where it just allows you to append
to the current list and then what can I
do at the very end after I'm all done
reading the whole file why don't I go
ahead and say for title in titles go
ahead and print out the current title so
it's two Loops now and we can come back
to the quality of that design but let me
go ahead here and rerun python of
favorites.pi let me increase the size of
my terminal window so we can focus just
on this and hit enter and now
[Music]
I'm just skimming
I don't think I'm seeing duplicates
although I am seeing some near
duplicates
for instance there's friends again and
if we keep going and going and going and
going
there's forensic yeah oh interesting so
that's curious
that I seem to have multiple friends and
I have this one here too so how might we
clean this up further I like your
instincts and that's it's a step closer
to it what are we gonna have to do to
really filter out those near duplicates
any thoughts
aware
[Music]
yeah what are the common mistakes to
summarize we could ignore the
capitalization altogether and maybe just
force everything to lower case or
everything to uppercase doesn't matter
which but let's just be consistent and
for those of you who might have
accidentally or instinctively hit like
the space bar at the beginning of your
input or even at the end we can strip
that off too stripping white space is a
common thing just to clean up user input
so let me go back into my code here and
let me go ahead and tweak the title a
little bit let me say that the current
title inside of this Loop is not going
to be just the current rows title but
let me go ahead and strip off from the
left and the right implicitly any white
space if you read the documentation for
the strip function it does just that it
gets rid of white space to the left
white space to the right and then if I
want to force everything to maybe
uppercase I can just uppercase the
entire string and remember what's handy
about python is you can chain some of
these function calls together by just
using dots again and again and that just
takes whatever just happened like the
white space got stripped off then it
additionally up cases the whole thing as
well so now I'm going to check whether
this specific title is in titles and if
not I'm going to go ahead and append
that title massaged into this different
format if you will so I'm throwing away
some information like I'm sacrificing
all of the nuances of your uh grammar
and input to the form itself but at
least I'm trying to canonicalize that is
standardize what the data actually looks
like so let me go ahead and run python a
favorite stop Pi again and hit enter oh
and this is just user error maybe you
haven't seen this before this just looks
like a
mistake on my part I meant to say not
even uppercase that's completely wrong
the function is called upper now that I
think of it all right let's go and
increase the size of the terminal window
again run python of favorites.pi and now
you know it's a little more overwhelming
to look at because it's not sorted yet
and it's all capitalized but
I don't think I'm seeing multiple
friends so to speak there's one friends
up here and that's it I'm back up at my
prompt already so we seem now to be
filtering out duplicates now before we
dive in further and clean this up uh
further than this what else could we
have done well it turns out that in
Python 2 you often do get a lot of
functionality built into the language
and I'm kind of implementing myself the
idea of a set if you think back to
mathematics a set is typically something
with a bunch of values that has
duplicates filtered out recall that
python already has this for us and we
saw it really briefly when I whipped up
the dictionary implementation a couple
of weeks back so I could actually Define
my titles to be a set instead of a list
and this would just modestly allow me to
refine my code here such that I don't
have to bother checking for duplicates
anyway I can instead just say something
like titles dot add the current uh title
like this you know marginally better
design if you know that a set exists or
you're just getting more functionality
out of this alright so let's clean the
data up further we've now gone ahead and
fixed the problem of case sensitivity we
threw away white space in case someone
hit the space bar with some of the input
let's go ahead now and sort these things
by the titles themselves so instead of
just printing out the titles in the same
order you all inputted them but in
filtering out duplicates as we go let me
go ahead and use another function in
Python you might not have seen which is
literally called sorted and will take
care of the process of actually sorting
titles for you let me go ahead and
increase the font size of my terminal
run python of favorites.pi and hit enter
and now you can really see how many of
these shows start with the word the or
do not now it's a little easier to wrap
our minds around just because it's at
least sorted alphabetically but now you
can really see some of the differences
in people's inputs so far so good but a
few of you decided to stylize Avatar in
three different ways here Brooklyn 99s a
couple of different ways here and I
think if we keep going we'll see further
and further variances that we did not
fix by focusing on white space and
capitalization alone so already here
this is only what 100 plus 200 rows
already real world data starts to get
messy quickly and that might not bode
well when we actually want to keep
around real data from real users you can
imagine an actual website or a mobile
application dealing with this kind of
thing on scale well let's go ahead and
do this let's actually figure out the
popularity of these various shows by now
iterating over my data and keeping track
of how many of you inputted a given
title we're going to ignore the problems
like Brooklyn Nine-Nine and uh the
Avatar sorry uh yeah uh Avatar where
there was things that were different
Beyond just white space and
capitalization but let's go ahead and
keep track of now how many of you
inputted each of these titles
so how can I do this I'm still going to
take this approach of iterating over the
CSV file from top to bottom
we've used a couple of data structures
thus far a list to keep track of titles
or a set to keep track of titles but
what if I now want to keep around a
little more information for each title I
want to keep around how many times I've
seen it before
I'm not doing that yet I'm throwing away
the total number of times I see these
shows how could I start to keep that
around
we could use a dictionary and how what
elaborate on that
perfect really good instincts using a
dictionary insofar as it lets us store
keys and values that is associate
something with something else this is
why a dictionary or hash tables more
generally are such a useful practical
data structure because they just let you
remember stuff in some kind of
structured way so if the keys are going
to be the titles I've seen the values
could be the number of times I've seen
each of those titles and so it's kind of
like just having a two column a two
column table on paper for instance if I
were going to do this on a piece of
paper I might just have a two columns
here where maybe this is the title that
I've seen and this is the count over
here this is in effect a dictionary in
Python it's two columns keys on the left
values on the right and this if I can
Implement in code will actually allow me
to store this data and then maybe do
some simple arithmetic to figure out
which is the most popular so let's do
this let me go ahead and change my
titles to not be a list not be a set
let's have it be a dictionary instead
either doing this or more succinctly two
curly braces that are empty gives me an
empty dictionary automatically what do I
now want to do I think most of my code
can stay the same but down here I don't
want to just blindly add titles to the
data structure I somehow need to keep
track of the count
and unfortunately if I just do this
let's do titles bracket title
plus equals one
this is a reasonable first attempt at
this because what am I doing if titles
is a dictionary and I want to look up
the current title therein you the Syntax
for that like before is titles bracket
and then the key you want to use to
index into the dictionary it's not a
number in this case it's an actual word
a title and you're just gonna increment
it by one and then eventually I'll come
back and finish my second Loop and do
things uh in terms of the order but for
now let's just keep track of the total
counts let me go ahead and increase my
terminal window let me do python of
favorites.pi and hit enter and huh How I
Met Your Mother is giving me a key error
what does that mean
and why am I seeing this and in fact
just just to give a little bit of a
breadcrumb here let me zoom out here let
me open up the CSV file again real
quickly and wow we didn't even get past
the second row in the file or the first
show in the file notice that How I Met
Your Mother somewhat lowercased is the
very first show in therein what's your
instinct for why this is happening
I don't have a starting point right I'm
adding one to what like I'm blindly
indexing into the dictionary using a key
How I Met Your Mother that doesn't yet
exist in the dictionary and so python
throws what's called a key error because
the key you're trying to use just
doesn't exist yet so logically how could
we fix this
we're close we got like half of the
problem solved but I'm not handling the
obvious now case of nothing being there
yeah
creating a
creating the counter itself so maybe I
could do something like this let me
close my terminal window and let me ask
a question first if the current title is
in the dictionary already
if title in titles that's going to give
me a true false answer it turns out then
I can safely say titles bracket title
plus equals one and recall this is just
shorthand notation for the same thing as
in C title plus one whoops typo don't do
that
that's the same thing as this but it's a
little more succinct just to say plus
equals one else if it's logically not
the case that the current title is in
the title's dictionary then I probably
want to say titles bracket title equals
feel free to just shout it out
zero I just have to put some value there
so that the key itself is also there all
right so now that I've got this going on
let me go ahead and undo my sorting
temporarily and now let me go ahead and
do this I can as a quick check let me go
ahead and just run the code AS is python
of favorites.pi I'm back in business
it's printing correctly no key errors
but it's not sorted and I'm not seeing
any of the counts let me just quickly
add the counts and there's a couple of
ways I could do this I could say print
out the title and then maybe let's do
something like uh how about just comma
titles bracket title so I'm going to
print two things at once both the
current title in the dictionary and
whatever its value is by indexing into
it let me increase my terminal window
let me run python of favorites.pi enter
and okay huh
none of you said a whole lot of TV shows
it seems what's the logical error here
what did I do wrong if I look back at my
code here
[Music]
yeah why so many zeros
exactly to summarize I initialized the
count to zero the first time I saw it
but I should have initialized it at
least to one because I just saw it or I
should change my code a bit so for
instance if I go back in here the
simplest fix is probably to initialize
to one because on this iteration of the
loop obviously I'm seeing this title for
the very first time or I could change my
logic a little bit I could do something
like this instead if the current title
is not in titles then I could initialize
it to zero and then I could get rid of
the else and now blindly index into the
titles dictionary because now on line 11
I can trust that lines 9 and 10 took
care of the initialization for me if
need be which one is better I don't know
this one's a little nicer maybe because
it's one line fewer but I think both
approaches are perfectly reasonable and
well designed but the key thing no pun
intended is that we have to make sure
the key exists before we presume to
actually increment oh this is wrong
don't this is this is incorrect out what
did I do wrong
okay yes there we go so otherwise
everyone would have liked this show once
and no matter how many people said the
same thing now the code is as it should
be so let me go ahead and open up my
terminal window again let me run python
of favorites.pi and now we see more
reasonable counts some of the shows
weren't that popular there's just ones
and maybe twos but I bet if we sort
these things we can start to see a
little more uh detail so how else can we
do this Well turns out when dealing with
um when dealing with a dictionary like
this let's go ahead and just sort the
titles themselves so let's reintroduce
the sorted function as I did before but
no other changes let me go ahead now and
run python of favorites.pi now it's just
a little easier to wrap your mind around
it because at least it's alphabetical
but it's not sorted by value it's sorted
by key but sure enough if we scroll down
there's something down here for instance
like uh let's see the office that's
definitely going to be a contender for
most popular 15 responses but let's see
what's actually going to Bubble up to
the top unfortunately the sorted
function only sorts dictionaries by keys
by default not by values but it turns
out in Python if you read the
documentation for the sorted function
you can actually pass in other arguments
that tell you tell it how to sort things
for instance if I want to do things in
reverse order I can add a second
parameter to the sorted function called
reverse and it's a named parameter you
literally say reverse equals true so
that the position of it in the comma
separated list doesn't matter if I now
rerun this after increasing my terminal
window you'll see now that it's in the
opposite order now adventure and and
with an E is at the bottom of the output
instead of the top
how can I tell it to sort by a different
part of the of the of a different um by
values instead of by key well let's go
ahead and do this let me go ahead and
Define a function I'm just going to call
it f to keep things simple and this F
function is going to take a title as
input and given a given title it's going
to return the value of that title so
actually maybe a better name for this
would be get value and or we could come
up with something else as well the
purpose of the get value function to be
clear is to take as input a title and
then return the corresponding value why
is this useful well it turns out that
the sorted function in Python according
to its documentation also takes a key
parameter where you can pass in crazy
enough the name of a function that it
will use in order to determine what it
should sort by by the key or by the
value or in other cases even other types
of data as well so there's a curiosity
here though that's very deliberate key
is the name of the parameter just like
reverse was the name of this other
parameter the value of it though is not
a function call it's a function name
notice I am not doing this no
parentheses I'm instead passing in get
value the function I wrote by its name
and this is a feature of python in
certain other languages just like
variables you can actually pass whole
functions around so that they can be
called for you later on by someone else
so what this means is that the sorted
function written by python they didn't
know what you're going to want to sort
by today but if you provide them with a
function called get value or anything
else now their sorted function will use
that function to determine okay if you
don't want to sort by the key of the
dictionary what do you want to sort by
this is going to tell it to sort by the
value by returning the specific value we
care about so let me go ahead now and
rerun this after increasing my terminal
python a favorites.pi enter here we have
now an example of all of the titles you
all typed in albeit Force to capitalize
Force to uppercase and with any white
space is thrown out and now the office
is an easy win over friends versus
Community versus Game of Thrones
Breaking Bad and then a lot of variants
thereafter so there's a lot of steps to
go through like this you know isn't that
bad once you've done it once and you
know what these functions are and you
know that these parameters exist but
it's a lot of work I mean that's 17
lines of code just to analyze a CSV file
that you all created by way of those
Google form submissions but it took me a
lot of work just to get simple answers
out of it and indeed that's going to be
among the goals for today ultimately is
how can we just make this easier it's
one thing to learn new things in Python
but if we can avoid writing code or this
much code that's going to be a good
thing and so one other Technique we can
introduce here that does allow us to
write a little less code is we can
actually get rid of this function it
turns out in Python if you just need to
make a function but it's going to be
used and then essentially thrown away
it's not something you're going to be
reusing in multiple places it's not like
a library function that you want to keep
around you can actually just do this you
can change the value of this key
parameter to be what's called a Lambda
function which is a fancy way of saying
a function that technically has no name
it's an anonymous function why does it
have no name well it's kind of stupid
that I invented this name on line 13. I
used it on line 16 and then I never
again used it right if there's only
being used in one place why bother
giving it a name at all so if you
instead in Python say Lambda and then
type out the name of the parameter you
want this Anonymous function to take you
can then say go ahead and return this
value now it's notice the
inconsistencies here when you use this
special Lambda keyword that says hey
python give me an anonymous function a
function with no name it then says
python this Anonymous function will take
one parameter notice there's no
parentheses and that's deliberate if
confusing it just tightens things up a
little bit
notice that there's no return keyword
which similarly tightens things up a bit
albeit inconsistently but this line of
code I've just highlighted is actually
identical in functionality to this but
it throws away the word def it throws
away the word get value it throws away
the parentheses and it throws away the
return keyword just to tighten things up
and it's well suited for a problem like
this where I just want to pass in a tiny
little function that does something
useful but it's not something I'm going
to reuse it doesn't need multiple lines
to take up space it's just a nice
elegant one-liner that's all the Lambda
function does it allows you to create an
anonymous function right then and there
and then the function you're passing it
to like sorted will use it as before if
indeed if I run python a favorite stop
Pi after growing my terminal window the
result is exactly the same and we see at
the bottom here all of those small
results
are any questions then
on this syntax on these ideas the goal
here has been to write a Python program
that just starts to analyze or clean up
data like this
[Music]
could you use the Lambda if it's just
returning immediately it's really meant
for one line of code generally so you
don't use the return keyword you just
say what it is you want to return
[Music]
good question could you do more in that
one line if it's got to be a more
involved algorithm yes but you would
just ultimately return the value in
question in short if it's getting it all
sophisticated you don't use the Lambda
function in Python you go ahead and
actually just Define a name for it even
if it's a one-off name JavaScript
another language we'll look at in a few
weeks makes heavier use I dare say of
Lambda functions and those that can
actually be multiple multiple lines but
python does not support that that
instinct
all right so let's go ahead and do one
other thing office was clearly popping
out of the code here quite a bit let's
go ahead and write a slightly different
program that maybe just focuses on the
office for the moments just focuses on
the office so let me go ahead and throw
most of this code away up until this
point when I'm inside of my inner loop
and let me go ahead and I don't even
want the global variable here all I want
to do is focus on the current title how
could I detect if someone likes the
office well I could say something like
uh how about this so counter equals zero
we'll just focus on the office if title
equals equals the office I could then go
ahead and say counter
uh plus equals one I don't need a key
there's no dictionary involved now it's
just a simple integer variable and then
down here I'll say something like uh uh
number of people who like the office is
whatever this value is and I'll put in
counter and curly braces and then I'll
turn this whole thing into an F string
all right let me go ahead and run this
python a favorites.pi enter number of
people who like the office is 15. all
right so that's great but let's go ahead
now and deliberately muddy the data a
bit all of you were very nice in that
you typed in the office but you could
imagine someone just typing office for
instance maybe there maybe there and
many people might just write office you
could imagine didn't happen here but
suppose it did and probably would have
if we had even more and more submissions
over time now let's go ahead and rerun
this program no changes to the code now
only 13 people like the office so let's
fix this the data is now as I mutated it
to have a couple of offices and many the
offices how can I change my python code
to now count both of those situations
what could I change up here
in order to improve this situation any
thoughts
yeah so I could just ask two questions
like that if title equals the office or
title equals equals uh just office for
instance and I'm still don't have to
worry about capitalization I don't have
to worry about spaces because I at least
threw that all away now I can go ahead
and rerun this code let me go over it
run it a third time okay so we're back
up to 15. so I like that
um but this could you can imagine this
not scaling very well right like Avatar
had three different permutations and
there were some others if we dug deeper
that there might have been more variants
could we do something a little more
general purpose well we could do
something like this if uh office in the
title this is kind of a cool thing you
can do with python it's very
english-like just ask the question
albeit tersely this interesting just got
me into trouble now all of a sudden
we're up to 16. does anyone know what
the other one is
foreign
what office
[Music]
oh interesting yes so they hit V and
okay
okay someone did that sure so DB office
um we so okay this one's actually gonna
be hard to correct for like I can't
really think of a general well
this is I mean this is actually a good
example of like data gets messy fast and
you could imagine doing something where
okay we could have like 26 conditions if
someone said the a office or the B
office or right you could imagine doing
that but then there's surely going to be
other typos that are possible so that's
actually a hard one to fix but in it
turns out we got lucky and now this is
actually the accurate count
um but the data is itself messy let me
show another way that just has another
tool to our toolkit it turns out that
there's this feature in many programming
languages python among them called
regular expressions and this is actually
a really powerful technique that will
just scratch the surface of here but
it's going to be really useful actually
maybe toward final projects in web
programming anytime you want to clean up
data or validate data and actually just
to make this clear give me a moment
before I switch screens here and let me
open up a Google form from scratch give
me just a moment to create something
real quick
if you've never noticed this before when
creating a Google form you can do like a
a question and if you want the user to
type in something very specific as a
short text answer like this you might
know that there's toggles like this in
Google's world like you can require it
or you can do response validation like
you could say what's your email
and then you could say something like
text
is an email so here's an example in
Google
forms how you can validate users input
but a feature most of you have probably
never noticed or cared about or used is
this thing called a regular expression
where you can actually Define a pattern
and I could actually re-implement that
same idea by doing something like this I
can say let the user type in anything
represented by dot star then an at sign
then something else then at a literal
period Then for instance something else
so it's very cryptic admittedly at first
glance but this means any character Zero
more times this means any character Zero
more times this means a literal period
because apparently dot means any
character in the context of these
patterns then this thing means any
character Zero more times so I should
actually be a little more nitpicky you
don't want zero or more times you want
one or more times so this with a plus
means any character one or more time so
there has to be be something there and I
think I want the same thing here one or
more times one or more times or Heck if
I want to restrict this form in some
sense to edu addresses I could change
that last thing to literally.edu and so
long story short even though this looks
I'm sure pretty cryptic there's this
sort of mini language built into Python
and JavaScript and Java and other
languages that allows you to express
patterns in a standardized way and this
pattern is actually something we can
Implement in code two and let me switch
back to python for a second just to do
the same kind of idea let me um so I'll
go back to my code here let me put up
for instance a summary of what it is you
can do and here's just a quick summary
of all of the available
uh some of the available symbols a
period represents any character dot star
or dot asterisk means zero or more
characters so the dot means anything so
it can be a or nothing it can be b or
nothing it can be a b a b c it can be
any combination of zero or more
characters change that to a plus and you
now Express one or more characters
question mark means something is
optional uh carrot symbol means start
matching at the beginning of the user's
input dollar sign means start matching
at the end of the user or stop matching
at the end of the user's input so we
won't play with all of these just now
but let me go over here and actually
tackle this office problem let me go
ahead and import a new library called
the regular expression Library import re
and then down here let me say this if r
e dot search
this pattern uh let's just search for
office quote unquote in the current
title then we're going to go ahead and
increase increase the counter so it
turns out that the regular expression
library has a function called search
that takes us its first argument a
pattern and then as its second argument
the string you want to analyze for that
pattern so it's sort of look for a
needle in this Haystack from left to
right let me go ahead now and run this
version of the program enter and now I
screwed up because I forgot my colon but
that's old stuff enter
huh number of people who like the office
is now zero so this seems like a big
thank you big step backwards
what did I do wrong
yeah
yeah so my I forced all my input to
uppercase so I probably need to do this
so we'll come back to other approaches
there let me rerun it now okay now we're
back up to 16. but I could even let's
say I could tolerate just the office how
about this or how about something like
or the office let me do this instead and
let me use these other special
characters this carrot sign means the
beginning of the string this dollar sign
weirdly represents the end of the string
I'm adding in some parentheses just like
in math just to add another symbol here
the or symbol here and this is saying
start matching at the beginning of the
user string check if the beginning of
the string is office or the beginning of
the string is the office and then you
better be at the end of the string so
they can't keep typing words before or
after that input let me go ahead and
rerun the program and now we're down to
15 which used to be our correct answer
but then we notice the all the V office
yes how can we deal with that it's going
to be Messier to deal with that but I
could how about if I tolerate any
character represented by dot in between
the an office now if I rerun it now I
really have this expressive capability
so this is only to say there are so many
ways in languages in general to solve
problems and some of these tools are
more sophisticated than others this is
one that you've actually probably
glanced at but never used in the context
of Google forms for years if you're in
the habit of creating these for student
groups or other activities but it's now
something you can start to leverage and
we're just scratching the surface of
what's actually possible with this but
let's now do one final example just
using some python code here and let's
actually write a program that's a little
more general purpose that allows me to
search for any given title and figure
out its popularity so let me go ahead
and simplify this let's get rid of our
regular expressions
let's go ahead and continue capitalizing
the title and let's go ahead to at the
beginning of this program and first ask
the user for the title they want to
search for so title equals let's ask the
user for input which is essentially the
same thing as our cs50 getstring
function ask them for the title and then
whatever they type in let's go ahead and
strip white space and uppercase the
thing again and now inside of my loop I
could say something like this uh if the
current rows title after stripping white
space and forcing it to uppercase 2
equals the user's title then go ahead
and maybe increment a counter so I still
need that counter back so let me go
ahead and Define this maybe in here
counter equals zero and then at the very
end of this program let me go ahead and
print out just the popularity of
whatever the human typed in so again the
only difference is I'm asking the human
for some input this time I'm
initializing my counter to zero then I'm
searching for their title in the CSV
file by doing the same massaging of the
data by forcing it to uppercase and
getting rid of the white space so now
when I run python of favorites.pi enter
I could type in the office all lowercase
even and now we're down to 13.
[Music]
13.
y
oh that's correct because I'm the one
that went in and removed those the
keywords a bit ago if we fixed those we
would be back up to 15 if we hadn't did
support for the V office we would be up
to 16 as well all right any questions
then on these various manipulations and
if you're feeling like oh my God this is
so much python code just to do simple
things that's the point and indeed even
though it's a powerful language and can
solve these kinds of problems we had to
write almost 20 lines of code just to
ask a single question like this but any
questions on how we did this
or on any of these building blocks along
the way
anything here
no all right that was a lot let's take a
five minute break here when we come back
we'll do it better
so we are back and the rest of today is
ultimately about how can we store and
manipulate and change and retrieve data
more efficiently than we might by just
writing raw code this isn't to say that
you shouldn't use Python to do the kinds
of things that we just did and in fact
it might be super common if you're
getting a lot of like messy input from
users that you might want to clean it up
and maybe the best way to do that is to
write a program so that step by step you
can make all of the requisite changes
and fixes like we did with the office
for instance again and again and reuse
that code especially if more and more
submissions are coming through but
another theme of today ultimately is
that sometimes there are different if
not better tools for the same job and in
fact now at this point in the term as we
begin to introduce not just python but
in a moment a language called SQL and
next week a language called JavaScript
and the week after that synthesizing a
whole lot of these languages together is
to just kind of paint a picture of like
how you might decide what the trade-offs
are between using this tool or this tool
or this other tool because on
undoubtedly you can solve problems
moving forward in many different ways
with many different tools so let's give
you another tool one with which you can
Implement a proper relational database
what we just saw in the form of CSV
files are what we might call flat file
databases again just a very simple file
flat in that there's no hierarchy to it
it's just like rows and columns and that
is all ultimately storing ASCII or
Unicode text a relational database
though is something that's actually
closer to a proper spreadsheet program
right like a CSV is an individual sheet
if you will from a spreadsheet when you
export it if you had multiple sheets in
a spreadsheet you would have to export
multiple csvs and that gets annoying
quickly in code if you have to open up
this CSV this CSV all of which represent
different sheets or tabs in a proper
spreadsheet a relational database is
more like a spreadsheet program that you
a programmer now can interact with you
can write data to it you can read data
from it and you can have multiple sheets
AKA tables storing all of your data so
whereas Excel and numbers in Google
spreadsheet are meant to be reused
really by humans with their Mouse and
their keyboard clicking and pointing and
manipulating things graphically a
relational database using a language
called SQL is one in which the
programmer has similar capabilities but
doing so in code specifically using a
language called SQL and at a scale
that's much grander than spreadsheets
alone in fact if you try on your Mac or
PC to open a spreadsheet that's got tens
of thousands of rows it'll probably work
fine hundreds of thousands of rows
millions of rows no way like at some
point your Mac or PC is going to
struggle to open particularly large data
sets and that too is where proper
databases come into play and proper
languages for databases come into play
when it's all about scale and indeed
most any mobile app or web app today
that you or someone else might write
should probably plan on lots of data if
it's successful so we need the right
tools for that problem so fortunately
even though we're are about to learn yet
another language it only does four
things fundamentally known by this silly
acronym crud
uh sequel this language for databases
supports the ability to create data read
data update data and delete data like
that's it there's a few more keywords
that exist in this language called SQL
that we'll soon see but at the end of
the day even if you're starting to feel
like this is a lot very quickly it all
boils down to these four basic
operations and the four commands in SQL
if you will functions in a sense that
Implement those four ideas happen to be
these they're almost the same but with
some slight variance the ability to
create or insert data is the C the
ability to select data is the r or read
update is the same delete is the same
but drop is also a keyword as well so
we'll see these and a few other keywords
in SQL that at the end of the day just
allow you to create read and update data
using verbs if you will like these so so
to do that what's the syntax going to be
well we won't get into the weeds too
quickly on this but here's a
representative syntax of how you can
create using this language called SQL in
your very own database a brand new table
right this is so easy in Excel in Google
spreadsheets and Apple Numbers you want
a new sheet you like click the plus
button you get a new tab you give it a
name and boom you're done in the world
of programming though if you want to
create the analog of that spreadsheet in
the computer's memory you create
something called a table like a sheet
that has a name and then in parentheses
has one or more columns but unlike
Google spreadsheets and Apple Numbers in
Excel you have to decide as the
programmer what types of data you're
going to be storing in each of these
columns now even though Excel and Google
spreadsheets and numbers does allow you
to format or present data in different
ways it's not strongly typed data like
it is for instance when we were using C
and heck even in Python there's
underlying data types even if you don't
have to type them explicitly databases
you're going to want to know are you
storing integer years are you storing
real numbers or floats are you storing
text why because especially as your data
scales the more hints you give the
database about your data the more
performant it can be the faster it can
help you get at and store that data so
types are about to be important again
but there's not going to be that many of
them fortunately now how can I go about
converting for instance some real data
like that from you my favorites.csv file
into a proper relational database well
it turns out that using SQL I can do
this in vs code on my own Mac or PC or
in the cloud here by just importing the
CSV into a database we'll see eventually
how to do this manually for now I'm
going to use more of an automated
process so let me go over to vs code
here let me type LS to see where we left
off before I had two files favorites.csv
which I downloaded from Google
spreadsheets recall that I made a couple
changes we deleted a couple of those
from the file for the office but this is
the same file as before and then we have
favorites.pi which we'll set aside for
now I'm going to go ahead now and run a
command SQL Lite 3 so in the world of
relational databases there's many
different products out there many
different software that implements the
SQL language Microsoft has their own
there's something called MySQL that was
that's been very popular for years
Facebook for instance used it early on
uh postgres SQL Microsoft Access server
Oracle and maybe another a whole bunch
of other product names you might have
encountered over time which is to say
there's many different types of tools
and servers and software in which you
can use SQL we're going to use a very
lightweight version of the SQL language
today called SQL Lite this is the
version of SQL that's generally used on
iPhones and Android devices these days
if you download an app that stores data
like your own contacts typically is
stored using SQL Lite because it's
fairly lightweight but you can still
store hundreds thousands even tens of
thousands of pieces of data even using
this lightweight version thereof sqlite3
is like version three of this tool we're
gonna go ahead and run SQL Lite 3 with a
5 file called favorites.db it's
conventional in the world of SQL Lite to
name your file something.db I'm going to
create a database called favorites.db
once I'm inside of the program now I'm
going to go ahead and enter CSV mode
again not something you have to memorize
just something you can look up as needed
and then I'm going to import
favorites.csv into a table that is a
sheet if you will called favorites as
well now I'm going to hit enter and I'm
going to go ahead and exit the program
altogether and type LS now I have three
files in my current directory the CSV
file the python file from before and now
favorites.db but if I did this right all
of the data you all typed into the CSV
file has now been loaded into a proper
database where I can now use this SQL
language to access it instead so let's
go ahead and again and run sqlite3 of
favorites.db which now exists and now at
the SQL Lite prompt I can start to play
around and see what this data is for
instance I can look by typing dot schema
and what the schema is of my data what's
the design now no thought was put into
the design of this data at the moment
because I automated the whole process
once we start creating our own databases
we'll give more thought to the data
types and the columns that we have but
we can see what SQL Lite presumed I
wanted just by importing the data by
default what the import command did for
me a moment ago is essentially the
syntax it automated the process of
creating a table if it doesn't exist
called favorites and then notice in
parentheses it gave me three columns
timestamp title and genres which were
inferred obviously from the CSV all
three of which have been decreed to be
text again once we're more comfortable
we'll create our own tables choose our
own types and column names but for now I
just automated the whole process just to
get us started by using this built-in
import command as well
all right so what now can I begin to do
well if I wanted to for instance start
playing around with data therein I might
execute a couple of different commands
um one of which
let me find the right one here one of
which would be
select select being one of our most
versatile tools to select data from this
database so if I have these three
columns here timestamp title and genres
suppose I want to select all of the
titles doing that earlier in Python
required importing the CSV Library
opening the file creating a reader or a
dict reader iterating over every row
adding every title to a dictionary or
just printing it out and dot dot right
there's like a dozen or so lines of code
when we first began now how about this
Select Title from favorites semicolon
done
so now with this particular language the
output is very textual and it's
simulating what it looks like if it were
more graphical by creating this table so
to speak Select Title from favorites is
a distillation in a different language
called SQL of all the lines of code I
wrote early on when we first started
playing with favorites.pi SQL is
therefore optimized for reading and
creating and updating and ultimately
deleting data so here's a perhaps a
better tool for the job once you have
the data tossing it into a more powerful
versatile format might allow you now to
get more work done more quickly without
having to reinvent the wheel someone
else has figured out how to select data
like this what more can I do here well
let me go ahead and pull up in a moment
just a little bit of a cheat sheet here
give me one second to find this
[Music]
so suppose I want to now select data a
little more powerfully so here's what I
just did in a canonical way so select
typically works like this you select
columns from a specific table semicolon
unfortunately stupid semicolons are back
select columns from table then is the
sort of generic form of what I just did
more specifically I selected one column
called title from favorites favorites is
the name of the table semicolon ends my
thoughts suppose I wanted to get two
things like the genres that each of you
inputted I could instead do Select Title
comma genres from favorites and then a
semicolon and enter it's going to look a
little ugly on my screen because some of
these titles and some okay one of you
really went all out with Community
you can see that it's just wrapping in
an ugly way but it's just now showing me
two columns if we scroll up to the very
top again the leftmost of one Black
Mirror went all out too thank you and
now okay we're gonna have to clean some
of these up Game of Thrones good comedy
yes
keep going keep going keep going so now
we've selected two of The Columns that
we care about there it is okay so it's
crazy wide because of all of those
genres but it allows me to select
exactly the data I want let's go back to
the titles though and perhaps start
playing around with some modifiers here
for instance it turns out using SQL
there's a lot of functionality built
into the language you've got a lot of
functions similar to Excel or Google
spreadsheets we can have formulas SQL
provides you with some of the same
heuristics that allow you to apply
operations like these on entire columns
for instance you can take averages count
the total get the distinct values Force
things to lower case uppercase Min and
Max and so forth so let's try distinct
for instance let me go back to my
terminal and let's say select how about
the distinct titles from the favorites
table enter I didn't bother selecting
the genres because I want it to be a
little prettier and you can see here
that we have just the distinct titles
except for issues of formatting right so
white space is going to be an issue
again capitalization is going to be a
thing again so there's a trade-off I
mean one of the things I was doing in
Python was forcing everything to
uppercase and then getting rid of white
space but we could combine some of these
I could do something like force every
title to uppercase then get the distinct
value and that's actually going to get
rid of some of those values as well and
again I did it all in one simple line
that was fast so let me pull up at the
bottom of the screen again I selected
distinct upper titles from favorites and
that did everything for me at once in
just one breath suppose I want to get
the total number of counts of titles how
about select uh count of all of those
titles from uh favorites semicolon enter
and now you get back sort of mini table
that contains just your answer 158 in
this case so that's the total number of
not distinct but total titles that we
had in the file and we could continue to
manipulate the the data further using
again functions like these here but
there's also additional filtration we
can do we can also qualify our
selections by saying where some
condition is true so just as in scratch
and C in Python you have Boolean
Expressions you can have the same in SQL
as well where I can filter my data where
something is true or false like allows
me to do approximations if I want to get
something that's like the office but not
necessarily th e space office I could do
pattern matching using like here order
by limit and group by or other commands
I can execute too so let me go back and
do a couple of these here how about let
me just get uh oh I don't know all of
the titles from favorites but limit it
to 10 results that might be one thing
that's helpful to see if you just care
about some of the data at the top there
instead how about select all of the
titles from favorites where the title
itself is like
quote unquote office and this will give
me only two answers those are the two
rows recalled that I mutated by getting
rid of the word the notice that like
allows me to tolerate uppercase and
lowercase because if I instead just use
the equal sign and in SQL in single
equal sign does in fact mean equality
it's not uh for comparison's sake it's
not doing assignment this is not how you
assign data in SQL I got back no answers
there so indeed the equal sign is giving
me literal answers that searches just
for what I typed in how could I get all
of these well similar in spirit to
regular Expressions but not quite as
powerful in SQL I could do something
like this I can select the title from
favorites where the title is like quote
unquote office but I can add a bit
weirdly percent signs to the left and
the right
so the language SQL supports the same
notion of pattern matching but much more
limited out of the box if we want more
powerful regular Expressions we probably
do want to use Python instead but the uh
percent sign here means zero or more
characters on the left zero or more
characters on the right so this will
just grab any title that contains o f f
i c e in it in that order and now I get
all 16 it would seem of those results
again how do I know it's 16 well I can
just get the count of those titles and
get back that answer instead as well so
again take some getting used to the
library the vocabulary and sort of the
syntax that you can use there's these
building blocks and others but SQL is
really designed again for creating
reading updating deleting data for
instance I've never really been a fan of
friends for instance so right now if I
do select how about title from favorites
where title like quote-unquote friends
with the percent signs we can see that
there's a whole bunch of them that's how
many exactly let's just do a quick count
so that's nine of them uh well delete
from
favorites okay you and me daily from
favorites where title like
friends enter nothing seems to happen
but bye bye friends so now we've
actually thank you
so now we've actually changed the data
and this is what's compelling about a
database a proper database yes you could
technically write python code that not
only reads the CSV file but also writes
it like you can change using quote
unquote a for append or quote unquote W
for right instead of quote unquote R for
read alone but it's definitely a little
more involved to do that in Python but
with SQL you can update the data in real
time and if I were actually running like
a web application here or a database for
a mobile app that change theoretically
would be reflected everywhere on your
own devices if you're somehow talking to
this application so that's sort of the
direction we're headed this other thing
has been bothering me so select uh how
about title from favorites
where uh title equals what was it the
the office was it yeah it was that one
how about we update favorites by setting
title equal to the office where title
equals quote unquote the V office
semicolon and now if I select the same
thing again I can go up and down with my
arrow keys quickly now there is no the V
office we've actually changed that value
how about genres select genres from
favorites where the title is title
equals Game of Thrones semicolon these
were kind of long and you know I don't
really agree with all of that so how
about we update favorites set genres
equal to I mean short action adventure
short drama okay so it's a decent list
fantasy sure Thriller War okay anything
really but comedy I would say
let's go ahead and hit enter now and now
if I select genres again same query now
we've sort of canonicalize that we've
thrown data away so whether or not that
is right is probably a bit subjective
and argumentative but I have at least
cleaned up my data which is again the U
in crud create read update delete you
can do it that easily beware using
delete beware worse using drop whereby
you can drop an entire table but via
these kinds of commands can we actually
now manipulate our data much more
rapidly and with single thoughts and in
fact if you're an aspiring statistician
or data scientist or analyst in the real
world I mean SQL is such a commonly used
language because it allows you to really
dive into Data quickly and ask questions
of the data and get back answers quite
quickly and this is a simple data set
you can do this with much larger data
sets as we soon will
two
are any questions on what we've seen of
SQL thus far only scratched the surface
but again it boils down to creating
reading updating and deleting data
[Music]
questions here
all right well let's consider the design
of this data recall that if I do dot
schema that shows me the design of my
table the so-called schema of my data
this is okay it gets the job done and
frankly everything the user typed in was
arguably text including the timestamp
which is the date and time but so the
data set itself is somewhat simple but
if we look at the data set itself
especially genres let's do this select
genres from favorites and let me point
out one other thing stylistically too I
am very deliberately capitalizing all of
the special SQL keywords and I'm
lowercasing all of the column names and
the table names this is a convention and
honestly it honestly it just helps you
read I think the code when you're
commingling your names for columns and
tables with proper SQL keywords but I
could just as easily do select genres
from favorites but again the SQL
specific keywords don't quite jump out
as much so stylistically we would
recommend this selecting genres from
favor it's semicolon so here is where
oh
okay that was not intended I
accidentally made every show including
the office about action adventure Drama
Fantasy Thriller and War
how did I do that accidentally
what did I do wrong
yeah so beware it's funny I think I did
say beware around this time so I the SQL
database took me literally I updated
favorites setting genres equal to that
semicolon end of thought I really wanted
to say where title equals quote-unquote
Game of Thrones unfortunately there
isn't an undo command or time machine
with a SQL database so the best we can
do here is let's actually get rid of
favorites.db let's run SQL Lite of
favorites dot DB again which now will be
recreated let me change myself into CSV
mode let me import into my favorites
table the CSV file and now
um friends is back for better for worse
but so are all of our genres so if I now
do select uh if I now reload the file
and do select star from sorry select
genres from favorites that was the
result I was getting it's much Messier
but that's because some of these are
quite long but now we're back to the
original data less than here be sure to
back up your work all right so what more
can we now do with this data well I
don't love the design of the genres
table for a couple of reasons one I mean
we didn't have any sort of validation
but user input is going to be messy
there's just a lot of redundancy in here
right like let's go ahead and do this uh
let me select all the comedies you all
typed in so Select Title from
uh favorites where genres equals
quote-unquote comedy
okay so there's
all of the shows that are explicitly
comedies but I think there might
actually be others let me scroll back up
here
comedy drama what was a comedy and a
drama how about let's search for the
oops let me copy paste comedy comma
drama
okay so the office in this case was
considered comedy and drama billions
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia and
Gilmore Girls as well but notice that I
get many more when I just search for
comedy so the catch here is that because
I have all of these genres implemented
the way Google did as a comma separated
list it's actually really hard and messy
to get at any show all of the shows that
are somewhere described as comedy right
because if I search for quote-unquote
comedy the only answers I'm gonna get
are this one Whatever that show is this
one Whatever that show is this one but
I'm not going to get this one I'm not
gonna get this one why if I'm searching
for where genres equals quote-unquote
comedy why am I missing those other
shows
why am I missing yeah
[Music]
exactly it's not just a comedy it's a
comedy and a drama and a comedy or a
news show and so forth so I have to
search for these commas so this gets
messy quickly right like let me copy
this so I can do this let me search for
where genres equals comedy uh how about
uh or genres equals comedy drama or
genres equals this whole thing comedy
News Talk Show I'm gonna get more and
more results but that's not going to
scale well what could I do instead of
enumerating with ores all of the
different permutations of genres do you
think
[Music]
yeah so I could use the keyword is
similar in Python to the word in I could
use the like keyword so that so long as
the genres is like comedy somewhere in
there that's going to give me all of
them so long as the word comedy is in
there but let me go ahead and just open
the form from earlier uh the form had
let me see if I can open this real quick
before I toggle over if we look back at
the form recall that there were all of
those radio buttons asking for the
specific genres into which something
fill and if I open this let me full
screen Here and Now open the original
form you'll see all of the genres here
none of which are that worrisome except
for
a corner case is jumping out at me where
might the like keyword alone get me into
trouble
it's not with comedy I'm okay with
comedy but
yeah music and musical are deliberately
on the list here because one there are
separate genres but if I just search for
something that's like music I'm going to
accidentally suck in all of the musicals
which might not be what I intend if
music is like a music video or whatever
and musical is actually a different type
of show I don't want to just do that so
it seems just very messy like I could
probably hack something together with
maybe add some commas in there or
something like this but this is just not
a good design for the data Google has
done it this way because it's just
simple to actually keep the user's data
all in a single column and just as they
did separate it by commas but this is a
real messy way to use csvs by putting
comma separated values in your comma
separated values arguably the folks at
Google probably just did this because
it's just simpler and they didn't want
to give people multiple sheets or
complicate things using some other
weirder character than commas alone but
I bet there's a better way for us to do
this and let me go ahead and do this let
me go back into my code here year and in
just a moment I'm going to grab a
program that I wrote in advance that's
going to use Python to open up the CSV
file iterate over all of the rows and
load the data into two tables this time
two tables one called shows and one
called genres so as to actually separate
these two things out give me just a
moment to grab the code and when I run
this I'll only have to run it once let
me go ahead and run python in a moment
and I'll reveal the results in a sec
uh this is going to be version 8 of The
Code online when I do this let me go
ahead and open up this file
give me a second to move it into this
directory
version eight okay so here we have
version 8 of this that's available
online that's going to do the following
and I'll gloss over some of the details
just so that it uh we don't get stuck in
the weeds of some of this code I'm going
to be using at the top of this program
as we'll soon see a cs50 library not for
the sake of get string or get int or get
float but because there's some built-in
SQL functionality that we didn't discuss
a couple of weeks back with the cs50
library itself but inside of the cs50
library we'll see there is a special
function called SQL that gives you the
ability using this weird URL like
looking thing technically called a URI
that allows me to open a file called
favorites.db and long story short all of
the subsequent code is going to iterate
over this favorites.csv file that we
downloaded and it's going to import it
into the SQL Lite database but it's
going to use two tables instead of just
one so give me just a moment to run this
and then I'll reveal the actual results
this is going to be run on favorites uh
dot CSV
[Music]
and taking a look here
give me just a moment
oh uh give me a sec
come on
come on this program should not be
taking this long
sorry
let's open this real fast
[Music]
whoops not that file
okay let me just skim this code real
quick to see where we've gone wrong with
favorite Sesame Street reader
reader title show ID insert into shows
genre split until we execute
all right this is me debugging in real
time all those times we encourage you to
use print this is me actually using
print
we'll see how quickly I can recover from
this python favorites version 8.
okay so here's me debugging in real time
it's printing oh maybe I just didn't
wait long enough okay so here we go what
I'm doing is printing out the dictionary
that represents each row that you all
typed in and we're actually making
progress all right I'm just didn't I was
too impatient and didn't wait long
enough so in a moment there we go all
right so all you have to do sometimes is
wait let me go ahead now and open this
file using SQL Lite 3. so in SQL Lite 3
I now have a different version of
favorites.db I named it number eight for
consistency once I've run the program I
can do dot schema to look inside of it
and here's what the two tables in this
database are going to look like I've
created a table called shows this time
to represent all the TV shows that are
favorites that has two columns one is
called ID one is called title but now
I'm going to start taking out for a spin
some of the other features of SQL and
besides there being text it turns out
there's a data type called integer
besides there being a data type to call
text there's also a special key phrase
that you can specify that the title can
never be null think back to our use of
null in C think back to the keyword none
in Python this is a database constraint
that allows you to ensure that none of
you can't have a favorite TV show like
if you submit the form you have to have
typed in a title for it to end up in our
database here and you'll notice one
other new feature and turns out on this
table I'm defining what's called a
primary key specifically to be the ID
column more on that in just a moment
meanwhile the second table my code has
created for me is we'll soon see gives
me a column called show ID and then a
genre the value of which is text that
can also not be null and then more on
this in a moment this table has what
we're going to call a foreign key
specifically the show ID column that
references shows ID so before we get
into the weeds of this this is now a way
of creating the relay nation in
relational database if I have two tables
now not just one they can somehow be
linked together by a common column in
other words the shows column
shows table is going to give me a table
with two columns an ID and a title every
title you gave me I'm going to assign a
unique value the genres table meanwhile
is going to associate individual genres
singular with that same ID and the
result of this to pop back to the uh the
terminal here is let's do this select
star from shows of this new database
and you'll see that I've given indeed
all of the shows you all typed in unique
identifiers I didn't filter out
duplicates or do anything beyond just
forcing everything to uppercase so
there's going to be some duplicates here
because I didn't want to get rid of
anyone's data but you'll see that indeed
I've given everyone a unique identifier
from the very first person who typed How
I Met Your Mother all the way down to
input number 158. meanwhile if I do
select star from genres which is now a
table not just a column in the original
data now you'll see a much better design
for this data notice what I've done here
let me go all the way to the top and
you'll see two columns one of which is
called show ID the other of which is
called genre
and again I wrote some code to do this
because I had to take Google's messy
output where everything was separated by
commas I had to tear away the commas and
then put each genre into this table by
itself even though we haven't introduced
the syntax via which we can reconstitute
the data and reassociate your genres
with your titles why at a glance might
this be a better design now
even though I've doubled the number of
tables from one to two
why is this probably
on the direction toward a better design
what might your instincts be
why is this cleaner again first time
with SQL why is it better perhaps that
we've done this with our genres table
can I come to you
why might this be better yep oh just
because we had the conversation before
about the commas
exactly it's as simple as that we've
cleaned up the data by giving every
genre every word in the genre's column
in the original Google spreadsheet its
own cell in this table if you will and
now notice show ID might appear multiple
times whoever typed in How I Met Your
Mother they only Associated one genre
with it and so we see that show id1 is a
comedy but whoever typed in I forget the
name of the second show offhand but that
person whoever was assigned show id2
checked off a whole bunch of the genres
boxes that happened again with uh show
ID three four persons five six seven
only checked one box and so you can see
now that we've Associated the data with
what we might call a one-to-many
relationship a one-to-many relationship
whereby for every one show in the show's
table it can now have many genres
associated with it Each of which is
represented by a separate
a separate row here so again if I go
ahead and select star from shows let's
limit it to the first 10 just to focus
on a subset of the data How I Met Your
Mother The Sopranos was the second input
there it would seem that now that I've
created the data in this way I could
ideally somehow
search the data but a little more
correctly I don't have to worry about
the commas I don't have to worry about
the hackish approach of Music being a
substring of musical but how can I
actually get back at this data well
let's go ahead and do this suppose I did
want to get back maybe all of the
comedies all of the comedies no matter
whether the person checked just the
comedy box or multiple boxes instead
how now given that I have two tables
could I go about selecting
only the titles of comedies like I've
actually made the problem a little
harder but again SQL is going to give me
a solution for this the problem is that
if I want to search for comedies I have
to check the genres table first and then
that what's that going to give me like
if I search the genres table for
comedies what's that going to give me
back
potentially yeah
maybe show ID so let me try that let me
do select show ID from genres where the
genre in a given row equals
quote-unquote comedy no commas no like
no percent signs because literally that
column now is singular words like comedy
or drama or the like let me go ahead and
hit enter here okay so I got back a
whole bunch of ID numbers now this could
very quickly get annoying it looks like
show ID one two four five six seven nine
and so forth are all comedies so I could
do something really crazy like Select
Title from shows where ID equals one or
ID equals two or ID equal I mean this is
not going to scale very well but this is
why SQL is especially powerful you can
actually compose one SQL question from
multiple ones so let's do this why don't
I select the title where the ID of the
show is in the following list of IDs
select show ID from genres where the
specific genre is quote unquote comedy
so I've got two SQL queries one is
deliberately nested inside of
parentheses that's going to give me back
that whole list of show IDs but that's
exactly what I want to then look up the
titles for by selecting title from shows
where the ID of the show is in that big
tall list and so now if I hit enter
I get back only those shows that were
somehow flagged as comedy whether you in
the audience checked one box for comedy
two boxes or all of the boxes somehow we
teased out comedy again just by using
that python script which loaded this
data not into one big table but instead
two and if we want to clean this up
let's do a couple of things let's
outside of the parentheses do order by
title this is a way of sorting the data
in SQL very easily now we have a whole
list of the same titles that are now
sorted and what was the keyword with
which I could filter out duplicates
yeah distinct so let's try this same
query but let's select only the distinct
titles from that whole query and notice
I very deliberately done it this way and
to this day anytime I'm using SQL I
don't just start at the beginning and
type out my whole thought and just get
it right on the first try I very
commonly start with the sub query if you
will the thing in parentheses just to
get myself one step toward what I care
about then I add to it then I add to it
then I add to it just like we've
encouraged in Python and C taking baby
steps in order to get to the answer you
actually care about like this one now
and other than this mistake which we
didn't fix because I re-imported the
data after accidentally changing
everyone's genre we now have an
alphabetized list of all of the same
data but now it's better designed
because we have it split across these
two tables
oh thank you we're okay just thanks
[Music]
what questions do we have if any here
questions on this approach
[Music]
oh now that we have a database how do we
transfer it to a CSV
there are ways to do that and in fact
there's a command within SQL Lite that
allows you to export your data back to a
CSV file if you want to email it to
someone you want them to be able to open
it in Excel or Google spreadsheets or
apple numbers or the like you can go in
the other direction generally though
once you're in the world of SQL you're
probably storing your data there long
term and you're probably updating it
maybe deleting it adding to it and so
forth for instance the one command I did
not show earlier is suppose someone uh
forgot a show let's see do I did I see
this in the output all right so Curb
Your Enthusiasm saw that last night is
Just yeah did anyone see it last night
yeah all right well just the one person
that checked that box so you and me uh
what's another show that didn't make the
list how about uh Seinfeld is now on
Netflix apparently so insert into
uh shows uh what do we want to insert
well we want to insert maybe an ID and a
title but you know I don't actually care
what the ID is so I'm just going to
insert a title and the value I'm going
to give to that title is going to be
quote unquote Seinfeld and then let me
go ahead and hit semicolon nothing seems
to happen but let me rerun the bigquery
from before looking for comedies and
unfortunately Seinfeld has not yet been
flagged as a comedy so let's get this
right too what intuitively I'm gonna
have to do to associate now Seinfeld
with my comedies
I just inserted into the shows table
what more needs to happen before we can
flag Seinfeld as a comedy
say again
yeah so I need to insert into the genres
table two things now a show ID
like this and then the name of the genre
which presumably is comedy what values
do I want to insert well the show ID I
better grab that oh I don't even know
what it is I'm gonna have to figure out
what that is so I could do this in a
couple of ways let me do a one-time
thing select star from shows where title
equals quote unquote Seinfeld semicolon
159. so now I could do insert into
genres a show ID and a genre name the
values 159 and quote unquote comedy
semicolon enter and now if I scroll back
in my history and execute that really
big query again looking for all distinct
comedies now Seinfeld has made the list
but I did this manually so I didn't
actually capitalize it let's clean that
up let's do update uh let's do update my
shows set title equals to Seinfeld
semicolon
no okay thank you where title equals
quote unquote Seinfeld let's not make
that mistake again enter and now if I
execute that really big query now
Seinfeld is indeed considered a
um a comedy so where are we going with
this well thus far we've been doing all
this pretty manually and this is
absolutely what an analyst a data
scientist type person might do if just
manipulating a pretty large data set
just to get at interesting answers that
might be across one two or even many
more tables eventually in a few weeks
we're going to start to automate all of
this by writing code in Python that
generates SQL to do this right if you go
to most any website on the internet
today and you for instance log in odds
are you're typing a username and
password clicking submit what's then
happening well the website might not be
implemented in Python but it's probably
implemented in some language python
JavaScript Java Ruby something else and
that language is probably using
something like a relational database to
use SQL to get your username get your
password and compare the two against
what what you've typed in and actually
it's hopefully not getting your actual
password but something called the hash
thereof but there's probably a database
involved doing that when you buy
something on amazon.com and you click
check out odds are there's some code on
Amazon server that's looking at what
unit is you add it to your shopping cart
and then maybe using a for Loop of some
sort in python or another language it's
doing a whole bunch of SQL inserts to
store in their database what it is you
bought there's other types of databases
too but SQL databases or relational
databases are quite popular so let's go
ahead and write one other program here
in Python that now merges these two
languages together whereby I'm going to
use SQL inside of a Python program so I
can Implement my sort of logic of my
program in Python step by step line by
line but when I want to get at some data
I can actually talk to a SQL database so
let me go ahead and open
Favorites dot python here dot pi and let
me go ahead and
throw away some of what we did earlier
and really just now add a sequel to The
Mix from the cs50 library let's import
the SQL function this will be useful to
use because most third-party libraries
that deal with SQL and python are more
complicated than they need to be so I
think you'll find this Library easier to
use let's then do the following create a
variable called DB for database I could
call it anything I want let's use that
URI which is a fancy way of saying
something that looks like a URL but that
actually opens up a database
on disk that is in the current folder
let's now ask the user for a title by
prompting them for a quote unquote title
like this and let's strip off any white
space just so that the data is not messy
and then let's go ahead and do this and
this is the new logic I'm going to go
ahead now and write a line of code that
uses python to talk to the original
favorites.db so again I'm not using the
two table database which is in
favorites8.db I'm using the original
that we imported from your own data and
I'm going to do the following I'm going
to use db.execute to execute a SQL
command inside of python I'm going to
select the count of
um shows
from the favorites table where the title
you typed in where the title user typed
in is like this question mark and why
I'm doing that is as follows just like
in C when we had percent s in SQL for
now the analog is going to be a question
mark So same idea different syntax
instead of percent s it's just a
question mark and using a comma outside
of this first string using cs50's
execute function I can pass in a SQL
string a command then any arguments I
want to plug into the question marks
they're in so the goal at hand is to
actually write a program that's going to
search favorites dot CSV AKA
favorites.db for the total number of
people that liked a particular show so
this is going to select the count of
people from the favorites table where
the title they typed in is like whatever
the user has just now typed in this DB
execute function returns a list it
returns a list of rows and you would
only know that by my telling you or
reading the documentation and therefore
if I want to get back the total count
I'm going to go ahead and grab the first
row from those rows because it's only
going to give me back the count and then
I'm going to go ahead and print out that
rows first value
but it's going to be a little weird
technically the column is going to be
called count star quote unquote which is
a little weird let me add one more
feature to the mix you can actually give
nicknames to columns that are coming
back especially if they are the result
of functions like this I can just call
that column counter in all lower case
that means I can now say get back the
counter
key inside of this dictionary so just to
recap what have we done we've imported
the cs50 library SQL function we've with
this line of code opened the
favorites.db file that you and I created
earlier by importing your CSV into SQL
Lite I'm now just asking the user for a
title they want to search for I'm now
executing this SQL query on that
database plugging in whatever the human
typed in is their title in order to get
back a total count and I'm giving the
count a nickname an alias of counter
just so it's more self-explanatory this
function DB execute no matter what
always returns a list of rows even if
there's only one row inside of it so
this line of code just gives me the
first and only row and then this goes
inside of that row which it turns out is
a dictionary
and gives me the key counter and the
value it corresponds to so what to be
clear is this doing let's go ahead and
run this manually in my terminal window
first let me run SQL Lite 3 on favorites
uh dot oh let's do this on favorites.db
let me import the data again so uh mode
CSV
dot Import in from favorites.csv into a
favorites table
so I've just recreated the same data set
that you all gave me earlier in
favorites.db if I were to do this
manually let's search for the office
again select count star from favorites
where title like and let's just manually
type it in for now uh the office we'll
search for the one with the the word the
semicolon I get back 12. but technically
notice what I get back I technically get
back a miniature table containing one
column and one row
what if I want to rename that column
that's where the ads keyword comes in so
select count Star as counter notice what
happens enter I just get back same
simple table but I've renamed the column
to be counter just because it's a little
more self-explanatory as to what it is
so what am I doing with this line of
code this line of code is returning to
me that miniature temporary table in the
form of a list of dictionaries the list
contains one row as we'll see and it
contains one column as we'll see the
column the key for which is counter so
let's now run the code itself I'm going
to get out of SQL Lite 3 and I'm going
to run python of favorites dot Pi enter
I'm being prompted for a title I'm going
to type in the office and cross my
fingers and there's that 12. why is it
12 well there's a typo again because I
re-imported the CSV I had deleted two of
those so we're back at the original data
set so there's 12 total that have quote
unquote the office in the title like
that
so what have we done we've combined some
python with some SQL but we've relegated
all of the complexity of searching for
something the selecting of something
gotten rid of all of the with keyword
the open keyword the for Loop the reader
the dict reader and all of that and it's
just one line of SQL Now sort of using
the best of both worlds
are any questions
on what we've just done here or how
any of this works
any questions here yeah
foreign
[Music]
does this function return more than one
row well let me let me is was that the
question yeah so let's do that by
changing the problem at hand this
program was designed just to select the
total count let's go ahead and select
for instance
um
all of the ways you all typed in the
office by selecting the title this time
if I do this in SQL Lite 3 whoops if I
do this in SQL Lite 3
let me go ahead and do this again after
increasing my terminal window let's do
it manually Select Title from favorite
where the title is like quote unquote uh
the office semicolon I get back all of
these different rows and we didn't even
notice this one there's actually another
little typo in there with some
capitalization of the E and the C and
the E that would be an example of a
query that gives me back there for
multiple rows so let's now change my
Python program if I now in my Python
program do this
I get back a whole bunch of rows
containing all of those titles I can now
do four row in rows I can print out the
current rows title and now manipulate
all of those things together let me keep
both on the screen let me run Python A
favorites.pi and that for Loop now
should iterate what 10 or more times
once for each of those titles and indeed
if I type in the office again enter
oops uh
row title what did I do wrong oh I
should not be renaming title to counter
this time so that's just a dumb mistake
on my part let me rerun it again and now
I should see after typing in the office
enter a whole bunch of the offices and
because I'm using like even the
miscapitalizations are coming through
because like is case insensitive doesn't
matter if it's uppercase or lowercase
whereas how to use the equal sign I
would get back only the same ones
capitalize correctly
all right any questions on this next
all right so let's transition to a
larger juicier data set and consider
some of the issues that arise when
actually now using SQL and skating
toward a world in which we're using SQL
for mobile apps web apps and generally
speaking very large data sets so let's
start with a larger data set just like
that give me just a moment to switch
screens over to
what we have for you today which is an
actual relational database that we've
created out of a real world data set
from IMDb so internetmoviedatabase.com
is a website where you can search for TV
shows and movies and actors and so forth
all using their database behind the
scenes IMDb wonderfully makes their data
set available as not CSV files but tsv
files tab separated values and so what
we did is before class we downloaded
those tsv files we wrote a Python
program similar to my favorites eight
dot Pi file earlier that read read in
all of those tsv files created some SQL
tables in an IMDb
database for you in SQL Lite that has
multiple tables and multiple columns so
let's go and wrap our minds around
what's actually in this data set let me
go back to vs code here and in just a
moment I'm going to go ahead and copy
the file which we've named shows.db
and I'm going to go ahead and increase
my terminal and do sqlite3 of shows.db
whenever playing around with a SQL Lite
database for the first time typing dot
schema is perhaps a good place to start
to give you a sense of what's in there
and things just escalated quickly like
there's a lot in this data set because
indeed there's going to be tens of
hundreds of thousands of rows in this
data set and also problem set 7 where
we'll look at the movie side of things
and not just the TV shows so what is the
schema that we have created for you from
IMDb is actual real world data one
there's a table called shows and notice
we've just added white Space by hitting
enter a bunch of times to make it a
little more stylistically readable the
shows table has an ID column a title
column a year and the total number of
episodes for a given show and the types
of those columns are integer text
numeric and integer so it turns out
there's actually a few different data
types that are worth being aware of when
it comes to creating tables themselves
in fact in SQL light it there's five
data types and only five fortunately one
of which is indeed integer negative or
positive numeric which is kind of a
catch-all for dates and times things
that are kind of numeric but are not
just integers and not just real numbers
for instance real number is what we've
generally thought of as float up until
now text of course is just text but
notice that you don't have to worry
about how big it is like in Python it
will size to fit and then there's blob
which is binary large object which is
for just like raw zeros and ones like
for files or things like that but we'll
generally use the other four of these
and so indeed when we imported this data
for you we decided that every show would
be given an ID which is just an integer
every show has of course a title which
should not be null otherwise Y is it in
the database every show has a year which
is numeric according to that definition
a moment ago and the total number of
episodes for a show is going to be an
integer what now is with these primary
keys that we mentioned earlier too a
primary key is the column that you
uniquely identifies all of the data in
our case with the favorites I
automatically gave each of your
submissions a unique ID so that even if
two or more of you typed in the office
your submission still had a unique
identifier a number that allowed me to
then correlate it with your genres just
as we saw a moment ago in this version
of imdbs there's also genres but they
don't come from us they come from
imdb.com and so a genre has a show ID
and a genre just like our database but
these are real world genres with a bit
more filtration notice though just like
my version there's a foreign key a
foreign key is the appearance of another
table's primary key
in its own table so when you have a
table like genres which is somehow
cross-referencing the original shows
table
if shows have a primary key called ID
and those same numbers appear in the
genres table under the column called
show ID by definition show ID is a
foreign key it's the same numbers but
it's foreign in the sense that the
number is being used in this table even
though it's officially defined primarily
in this other table this is what we mean
by relational databases you have
multiple tables with some column in
common numbers typically and those
numbers allow to align the two tables up
in such a way that you can reconnect the
shows with their genres just like we did
with our smaller data set a moment ago
this logic is extended further notice
that the IMDb database we've created for
you has a Stars table like a TV show
Stars the actors they're in and that
table interestingly has no mention of
people and no mention of shows per se it
only has a column called show ID which
is an integer and a person ID which is
an integer meanwhile while if we scroll
down to
um if we scroll down to the bottom you
will see a table called people and we
have decided in IMDB's world that every
person in the movie in the TV show world
will have a unique identifier that's a
number a name that's text a birth date
which is numeric and then again
specifying that ID is going to be their
primary
primary key so what's going on here well
it turns out that TV stars and writers
are both types of people so using this
relational database notice the the
um the road we're going down we're sort
of factoring out commonalities and if a
person can be different things in life
well we're defining them first and
foremost as people and then notice these
two tables are almost the same the Stars
table has a show ID which is a number
and a person ID which is a number which
allows us via US this middleman table if
you will to link people with TV shows
similarly The Writer's table allows us
to connect shows with people too by just
recording those numbers so if we go into
this data set let's do the following
let's do select star from people
semicolon it's a huge amount of data is
coming back right this is hundreds of
thousands of rows now based on the ID
numbers alone so this is a real world
data now flying across the screen
there's a lot of people in the TV show
business not just actors and writers but
others as well
it's still going there's a lot of data
there so my God like if you had to do
anything manual in this data set it's
probably not going to work out very well
and actually we're up to what a million
people in this data set plus which would
mean this probably isn't even going to
open very well in Excel or Google
spreadsheets or Apple Numbers SQL
probably is the better approach here
let's search for someone specific like
select star from people where name
equals like Steve Carell for instance
sticking with comedies all right so
there's Steve Carell he is person number
797 born in 1962 and that's as much data
as we have on Steve Carell here how do
we figure out what shows for instance
he's in well let's see select star from
shows semicolon
there's a crazy number of shows out
there in the IMDb database and you can
see it here again flying across the
screen feels like we're going to have to
employ some techniques in order to get
at all of Steve Carell's shows
so how are we going to do that well God
this is a lot of data here and in fact
yeah we have what uh 15 million shows
Plus in this data set too so doing
things efficiently is now going to start
to matter so let's actually do this let
me select a specific show select star
from shows where title equals quote
unquote the office and there presumably
shouldn't be typos in this data because
it comes from the real website imdb.com
let's get back the show turns out
there's been a lot of the offices out in
the world the one that started in 2005
is the one that we want presumably the
most popular with 188 episodes how can
we get just that maybe we could do like
and year equals uh how about 2005. all
right so now we've got back just the ID
of the office that we care about and
let's do this too let me turn on a timer
within SQL Lite just to get a sense of
running time now let me do that again
select star from shows where title
equals the office and year equals 2005
and let's keep it simple let's just do
titles for now enter all right so not
terribly long it found it pretty fast
but it looks like it took how much real
time 0.02 seconds not bad for just a
title but just to plant a seed it turns
out that we can probably speed even this
up let me do this let me create
something called an index which is
another use of the C in crud for
creating something and I'm going to call
this like title index and I'm going to
create it on the shows table
uh specifically on the title column and
we'll see in a moment what this is going
to do for me enter
took a moment like .349 seconds to
create something called an index but now
watch if I select star from shows
searching for the office again
previously it took me .021 seconds not
bad but now
wow like literally no time at all or so
low that it wasn't really measurable and
I'll do it again just to get a sense of
things still quite low now even though
0.021 seconds not crazy long imagine now
having a lot of data a lot of users
running a real website a real mobile app
every millisecond we can start to shave
off is going to be compelling so what is
it we just did well we actually just
created something called an index and
this is a nice way to tie in now some of
our week five discussion of data
structures and our week three discussion
of running times in index in a database
is some kind of fancy data structure
that allows the database to do better
than linear search I mean literally as
you just saw these tables are crazy long
or tall right now very linear that is
and so when I first searched for the
office it was literally doing linear
search top to bottom looking at as many
as like what a million plus rows that's
relatively slow I mean it's not that
slow 0.021 seconds but that's relatively
slow just theoretically I'll go
rhythmically doing anything linearly but
if you instead create an index using
syntax like this which I just did
creating an index on the title column of
the shows table that's like giving the
database a clue in advance saying hey I
know I'm going to search on this column
in this table a lot do something with
data structures to speed things up and
so if you think back to our discussion
of data structures maybe it's using a
tree maybe it's using a try or a hash
table some fancier two-dimensional data
structure is generally going to lift the
data up creating right maybe a tree
structure so it's just much faster to
find data especially if it's sorting it
now based on title and not just storing
in one long list and in fact in the
world of relational databases the type
of structure that's often used in a
database is something called a b tree
it's not a binary tree different use of
the letter B but it looks a little
something like the table the trees we've
seen it's not binary because some of the
nodes might have more than two children
or fewer but it's a very wide but
relatively shallow tree it's not very
tall and the upside of that is that if
your data is stored in this tree the
database can find it more quickly and
the reason it took like half a second a
third of a second to build the index is
because SQL light needed to take some
non zero amount of time to just build up
this tree in memory and it has
algorithms for doing so based on like
alphabetization or other techniques but
you spend a bit of time up front a third
of a second and then thereafter wow like
every subsequent query if I keep doing
it again and again is going to be crazy
low 0.000 maybe 0.001 but in order of
magnitude a factor of 10 or 100 faster
than it previously was earlier
so we have these indexes which allow us
to get at data faster but what if we
want to actually get data that's now
across these multiple tables how can we
do that and how might these indices or
indexes help further Well turns out
there is a way that we've seen already
indirectly to join two tables together
previously when I selected the ID of the
office and then I searched for it in the
other table using select in a nested
query I was kind of joining two tables
together and it turns out there's a
couple of ways to do this let's go ahead
now and for instance find all of like
Steve Carell's TV shows not just the
office but all of them too unfortunately
if we look at our schema
shows up here have no mention of TV
shows over here has no mention of the TV
stars in them
and people have no mention of shows we
somehow need to use this table here to
connect the two and this is called a
join table in the sense
that using two integer columns it kind
of joins the two tables together
logically and so if you're kind of Savvy
enough with SQL you can kind of do what
I did with my hands earlier and like
recombine Tables by using these common
IDs these integers together so let me do
this let me go ahead and figure out step
by step Steve Carell show so how am I
going to do this well if I select star
from people where name equals Steve
Carell fortunately there's only one of
them so this gives me back his uh his
name his name his ID and his birth year
but it's really only his ID that I care
about why because in order to get back
his shows I need to link person ID with
show ID right so I need to know his ID
number so what could I do with this well
remember the schema and the Stars table
I've just gotten from the people table
Steve Carell's ID I bet by transitivity
I could now use his person ID his ID to
get back all of his show IDs and then
once I've got all of his show IDs I can
take it one step further and get back
all of his Show's title so the answer is
actually English words and not just
random seemingly integers so let me go
ahead and do this let me again get Steve
Carell's
ID number but not star star represents
everything it's a wild card character in
SQL let me just select the ID of Steve
Carell and that gives me back 136 797
and it's only giving me back one value
the thing called ID is just the column
heading up above now suppose I want to
select all of the show IDs that Steve
Carell is affiliated with let me select
show ID from Stars where the person ID
in Stars
happens to equal Steve Carell's ID so
again I'm sort of building up my answer
in reverse and taking these baby steps
on the right in parentheses I'm getting
Steve Carell's ID on the left I am now
selecting all of the show IDs that have
some connection with that person ID in
the Stars table this answer too is not
going to be that Illuminating it's just
a whole bunch of integers that have no
meaning to me the human but let's take
this one step further and even though my
code is getting long I could but hit
enter and kind of format it nicely
especially if I were doing this in a
code file but I'm just doing it
interactively for now let's now select
all of the titles from the shows table
where the ID of the show is in this
following previous query so again the
queries getting long but notice it's the
last third and last step Select Title
from the shows table where the ID of the
show is in the list of all of the show
IDs that came back from the Stars table
searching for Steve corel's person ID
how did we get that person ID let me
scroll to the end well I selected in my
innermost parentheses Steve carells
own ID so now when I hit enter voila I
get all of Steve Carell's TV shows up
until now and if I want to tidy this up
further I can use the same tricks as
before order by title semicolon now I've
got it all alphabetized as before so
again with SQL comes the ability to
search I mean look how quickly we did
this .094 seconds to search across three
different tables to get back this answer
but my data is now all kind of neatly
designed in individual tables which is
going to be important now that the data
set is so large but but let me take this
one step further let me go ahead and do
this let me go ahead and
point out that with this query notice
that I'm searching on
uh let's say
I'm searching on a person ID here and at
the end here I'm searching on a name
column here so let me actually go ahead
and do this let me go ahead and
see if we can't speed this up this query
at the moment takes .092 seconds let's
see if we can't speed this up further by
just quickly creating a few more of
those B trees in the databases memory
create an index called person index and
I'm going to do this on the Stars table
uh on the person ID column enter it's
taking a moment taking a moment that's
almost a full second because that's a
big table let's create another index
called show index on the Stars table why
because I want to search by the show ID
also that was part of my bigquery it
takes a moment okay just more than two
third about two-thirds of a second now
let's create one last one another index
called name index but I could call these
things anything I want on the people
table why because I'm also searching on
the name column so in short I'm creating
indexes on each of the columns that are
somehow involved in my search query
going from one table to the other now
let's go back to the previous query
which recall took Point o whoops that
took
um
I think I erased it
.091 all right well it was roughly this
order of magnitude we're not seeing the
data now but let me go ahead and run my
original bigquery once and boom we're
down to almost nothing so again creating
these indexes in memory has the effect
of rapidly speeding up our computation
time now if you've ever used for
instance uh the my.harvard core shopping
tool here on campus or Yale's analog you
might wonder like why is the thing so
slow this could be one of the reasons
why large data sets with thousands of
rows thousands of courses tend to be
slow if and I'm only conjecturing if the
database isn't properly indexed if
you're building your own web application
and you're finding that users are
waiting and waiting and things are
spinning and spinning what might be
among the problems what could absolutely
just be bad algorithms and bad code that
you wrote or it might be that you
haven't thought about well what columns
should be optimized for searches and
filtration like I've done here in order
to speed up subsequent queries again
from the outside in we can only conject
picture but ultimately this is just one
of the things that explains performance
problems as well all right let's point
out just a couple of final syntactic
things and then we'll consider bigger
picture some problems that might arise
in this world
if these nested nested queries start to
get a little much there are other ways
just so you've seen it that you can
execute similar logic in SQL for
instance if I know in advance that I
want to connect Steve Carell to his show
IDs and to their titles we can do
something more like this
Select Title from the people table
joined with the Stars table on whoops on
people ID equals stars.person ID so what
am I doing new syntax and again this is
not something you'll have to memorize or
ingrain right away but just so you've
seen other approaches Select Title from
people join Stars this is an explicit
way to say take the people table in one
hand the Stars table and in the other
hand and somehow join them as I keep
doing with my fingertips here how to
join them join them so that the people
the ID column in the people table lines
up with the person ID in the Stars table
but that's not quite everything I could
also say join further on the shows table
where uh the Stars show ID
equals the show's ID column so what am I
doing here that's saying go further and
join the star the people table sorry the
Stars table with the shows table joining
the show ID column with the ID column
again it's this starts to get a little
messy to think about but now I can just
say where name equals quote unquote
Steve Carell I can do in one query what
previously took me three nested queries
and get back the same answers and I can
still add in my order by title to get
back the result and if I do this a
little more
uh neatly let me type this out a little
differently let me type this out by
adding a new line uh I can't do that
here
I'm going to leave it alone for now we
can type it on multiple lines in other
contexts and let me do one last
thing so I want to show that I'm going
to show it but this is not something you
should ingrain just yet either Select
Title from people stars and shows if you
know in advance that you want to do
something with all three tables you can
just enumerate them one table name after
the other and then you can say where
people.id equals stars.person ID and now
I'm hitting enter so that it formats a
little more readably on my screen and
stars.show ID equals shows.id and lastly
name equals Steve Carell in short you
specify that you want to select data
from all three of these tables and then
you tell the database how to combine
foreign keys with primary keys that is
the columns that have those integers in
column common if I hit enter now I get
these same exact results ever more so if
I also add in an order by title oops uh
that's why I didn't want to do this
earlier right I'd have to hit I'd have
to go back through my history multiple
times to actually get back the
multi-line query this time all right
that was a lot all at once but this is
only to say that even as we sort of make
the design of the data more
sophisticated and we put some of it over
here some of it over here some of it
over here so as to avoid duplication of
data weird hacks like putting commas in
the data we can still get back all of
the answers that we might want across
these several tables and using indexes
we can significantly speed up these
processes so as to handle 10 times as
many a hundred times as many users on
the same actual database there is going
to be a downside and thinking back to
our discussion of algorithms and data
structures in past weeks what might be a
downside of creating these indexes
because as of now I created four
separate indexes on the name column the
title column and some other columns too
like why wouldn't I just go ahead and
index everything if it's clearly
speeding things up
memory so space anytime you're starting
to benefit time wise in computer science
odds are you're sacrificing space or
vice versa and probably indexing
absolutely everything is a little dumb
because you're going to create what
you're going to waste way more space
than you might actually need so figuring
out where the right inflection point is
is part of the process of Designing and
just getting better at these things
now unfortunately a whole lot of things
can go wrong in this world and they
continue to in the real world with
people using SQL databases in fact here
on out if you're reading something
technical about SQL databases and
websites being hacked in some form and
passwords leaking out unfortunately all
too often it is because of what are
called SQL injection attacks and just to
give you a sense now to counterbalance
maybe any enthusiasm for like oh that
was neat how we can do things so quickly
with great power comes responsibility in
this world too and so many people
introduce bugs into their code by not
quite appreciating what it is that um
how it is the data is getting into your
application so what do I mean by that
here for instance is a typical login
screen for Yale and here's the analog
for Harvard where you're prompted like
every day probably for your username and
your password your email address and
your password Here suppose though that
behind this login page whether harvards
or yales there's some websites and that
website is using SQL underneath the hood
to store all of the Harvard or Yale
people's usernames passwords ID numbers
courses transcript all of that stuff so
there's a SQL database underneath the
website well what might go wrong with
this process unfortunately there's some
special syntax in SQL just like there is
in C in Python for instance there are
comments in SQL two if you do two
hyphens dash dash that's a comment in
SQL and if you the programmer aren't
sufficiently distrustful of your users
such that you defend against potentially
adversarial attacks you might do
something like this suppose that I
somewhat maliciously or uh seriously log
in by typing my username
maylandharbor.edu and then maybe a
single quote and a Dash Dash why because
I'm trying to suss out if there is a
vulnerability here to a SQL injection
attack do not do this in general but if
I were the owner of the website trying
to see if I've made any mistake I might
try using potentially dangerous
characters in my input dangerous how
because single quote is used for quoting
things in SQL as we've seen single
quotes or double quotes dash dash I
claim now is used for commenting but
let's now imagine what the code
underneath the hood might be for
something like Yale's login or Harvard's
login what if it's code that looks like
this
so let me read it from left to right
suppose that they are using something
like cs50's own execute function and
they've got some SQL typed into the
website that says select star from users
where username equals this and password
equals that and they're plugging in
username and password
so what am I doing here well when the
user types their username password hits
enter I probably want to select that
user from my database to see if the
username and passwords match so the
underlying SQL might be select star from
users where username equals question
mark and password equals question mark
users is the table one column is
username one column is password all
right and if we get back one row
presumably mailing and harvard.edu
exists with that password we should let
him proceed from there on out so that's
like some pseudo code if you will for
this scenario what if though this code
is not as well written as it currently
is and isn't using question marks so the
question mark syntax is a fairly common
SQL thing where the question marks are
used as placeholders just like in printf
percent s was but these function
db.execute from cs50s library and
third-party libraries as well is also
doing some good stuff with these
question marks and defending against the
following attack suppose that you were
not using a third-party Library like
ours and you were just manually
constructing your SQL queries like this
you were to do something like this
instead using an F string in Python
you're comfortable with form map strings
now you've gotten into the habit of
using curly braces and plugging in
values suppose that you the aspiring
programmer is just using techniques that
you've been taught so you have an F
string with select star from users where
username equals quote unquote username
and curly braces and password equals
quote unquote password in curly braces
right like as of that what two weeks ago
this was perfectly legitimate technique
in Python to plug in values into a
string but notice if you are using
single quotes yourself and the user has
typed in single quotes to their input
what could go wrong here like where are
we going with this
if you're just blindly plugging user
input into your own prepared string of
text yeah
[Music]
yeah worst case they could insert what
is actually SQL code into your database
as follows generally speaking if you're
using special syntax like single quotes
to surround the user's input you'd
better hope that they don't have an
apostrophe or in their name or you
better hope that they don't type a
single code as well because what if
their single quote finishes your single
quote instead and then the rest of this
is somehow ignored well let's consider
how this might happen let me go ahead in
here it's got a little blurry here but
let me plug in here wow that looks awful
let me fix the red
just change this to White so it's more
readable what happens if the user does
this instead
they type in like I did into the
screenshot mailing at harvard.edu single
quote dash dash what has just happened
logically even though we've only just
begun with SQL today well select star
from users where username equals mailing
harbor.edu end quote
what's bad about the rest of this
dash dash I claim means a comment which
means my color coding is going to be a
little blurry again but everything after
the dash dash is just ignored the logic
then of the SQL query then is to just
say select mailing harbor.edu from the
database not even checking the password
anymore therefore you will get back at
least one row so length of rows will
equal one and so presumably the rest of
the pseudo code logs the user in gives
them access to my my DOT Harvard account
or whatever it is and they've pretended
to be me simply by using a single quote
and a Dash Dash in the username field
again please don't go start doing this
later today on Harvard Yale or other
websites but it could be as simple as
that why because the programmer
practiced what they were taught which
was just to use curly braces to plug in
in fstrings values but if you don't
understand how the user's input is going
to be used and if you don't distrust
your users fundamentally for every good
person out there there's going to be
unfortunately some adversary who just
wants to try to find fault in your code
or hack into your data set this is
what's known as a SQL injection attack
because the user can type something that
happens to be or look like SQL and trick
your database into doing something it
didn't intend to like for instance
logging the user in worst case they
could even do something else maybe the
user types a semicolon then the word
drop or the word update you could
imagine doing semicolon update table
grades where name equals mailing and set
the grade equal to a instead of b or
something like that the ability to
inject SQL into the database means you
can do anything you want with the data
set either constructively or worse
destructively all right and now just a
quick little cartoon that should now
make sense
[Music]
okay it's like one of us two of us
awkwardly so much funny all right so
let's move on to one last condition
there's one other problem that can go
around here oh and I should explain this
so this is an allusion to uh the son
Robert having typed in semicolon the
word drop table students and doing some
of the same technique this is sort of
humor that only CS people would
understand because it's the mom
realizing oh her son's doing a SQL
injection attack onto the database less
money when you explain it but if once
you notice the syntax that's all this is
an illusion to all right so one final
threat now that you are graduating to
the world of proper databases and away
from CSV files alone things can go wrong
when using databases and honestly even
using CSV files if you have multiple
users and thus far you and I have had
the luxury in almost every program we've
written that it's just me using my code
it's just you using your code and even
if you're teaching fellow or ta is using
it probably not at the same time but the
world gets interesting if you start
putting your code on phones on websites
such that now you might have have two
users literally trying to log in at the
same time literally clicking a button at
the same or nearly the same time what
happens then if a computer is trying to
handle requests from two different
people at once as might happen all the
time on a website you might get what are
called race conditions and this is a
problem in Computing in general not just
with SQL not just with python really
just any time you have shared data like
a database as follows this apparently is
one of the most liked Instagram posts
ever it is literally just a picture of
an egg has anyone clicked on this egg it
was like okay wow all right so yes so go
search for this photo if you'd like to
add to the likes on Instagram the
account is world record egg this is just
a screenshot of Instagram of that
picture of an egg if you're an habit of
using Instagram or like any social media
site there's some equivalent of a like
button or a heart button these days and
that's actually a really hard problem
such a simple idea to like count the
number of likes something has but that
means someone has to click on it your
code has to detect The Click your code
has to update the database and then do
it again and again even if multiple
people or perhaps right now clicking on
that same egg and unfortunately bad
things can happen if two people try to
do something this at the same time on a
computer
how might this happen so here's some
more code sap pseudo code have python
code here as follows suppose that what
happens when you literally right now
maybe click on the like button on the
Instagram post
suppose that code like the following is
executed on Facebook servers db.execute
of Select likes from Posts where ID
equals question mark all right so what
am I assuming here I'm assuming that
that photograph has a unique ID it's
like some big integer whatever it was
randomly assigned I'm assuming that when
you click on the heart the unique ID is
somehow sent to Instagram server so that
their code can call it ID and I'm
assuming that Instagram's using its SQL
database and selecting from a posts
table the current number of likes of
that egg
for that given ID number why because I
need to know how many likes it already
has if I want to add one to it and then
update the database right I need to
select the data then I need to update
the data here all right so in some
python code here let's store in a
variable called likes whatever comes
back in the first row from the likes
column again this is new syntax specific
to our library but a common way of
getting back first row and the column
called likes therein so at this point in
the story likes is storing the total
number of likes in the millions or
whatever it is of that particular egg
then I do this execute update posts set
the number of likes equal to this value
where the ID of the post equals this
value what do I want to update the likes
to whatever likes currently is plus one
and then plugging in the ID so a simple
idea right I'm checking the value of the
likes and maybe it's 10. I'm changing 10
to 11 and then updating the table but a
problem can arise if two people have
clicked on that egg at roughly the same
time or literally the same time why is
that well in the world of databases and
servers and the Instagrams of the world
have thousands of physical servers
nowadays so they can support millions
billions even of users nowadays what can
go wrong well typically code like this
is not what we'll call Atomic to be
Atomic means that it all executes
together or not at all rather code
typically is executed as you might
imagine line by line and if your code is
running on a server that multiple people
have access to which is absolutely the
case for an app like Instagram if you
and I click on the heart at roughly the
same time for efficiency the computer
the server owned by Instagram might
execute this line of code for me then it
might execute this line of code for you
then this line of code for me then this
line of code for you then this line of
code for me then this line of code for
you that is to say our queries kind of
might get intermingled uh
chronologically because it'd be a little
obnoxious if when you're using Instagram
I'm blocked out while you're interacting
with the site it'd be a lot nicer for
efficiency and fairness if somehow they
do a little bit of work for me a little
bit of work for you and back and forth
and back and forth equitably on the
server so that's what typically happens
by default these lines of code get
executed independently and they can
happen in alternating order with other
users you can get them sort of combined
like this same same order top to bottom
but other things might happen in between
so suppose that the number of likes at
the very beginning was like 10 and
suppose that Carter and I both click on
that egg at roughly the same time and
suppose this line of code gets executed
for me and that gives me a value in
likes ultimately of 10. suppose then
that the computer takes a break from
dealing with my request does the same
code for car harder and gets back what
value for the current number of likes
also 10 for Carter because mine has not
been recorded yet at this point in the
story somewhere in the computer's memory
there's a likes variable for me storing
10 there's a likes variable represent
storing 10 for Carter then this line of
code executes for me it updates the
database to be likes plus one which
stores 11 in the database then Carter's
code is executed updating the same Row
in the database to
11 unfortunately because his value of
likes happen to be the same value of
mine and so the metaphor here that if we
had a refrigerator on stage we would
actually act out is something that was
taught to me years ago in an operating
systems class whereby the kind of most
similar analog in the real world would
be if like you've got like a mini fridge
in your dorm room and you and a roommate
uh are uh one of you and your roommates
comes home opens the fridge and realizes
like oh we're out of milk was how the
story went in my day so you close the
refrigerator and you walk across the
street go to CVS and get in line to buy
some milk Meanwhile your roommate comes
home they too inspect the state of your
refrigerator AKA a variable open the
door and realize this oh we're out of
milk I'll go get more milk close the
fridge go across the street and head to
maybe a different store or the line is
long enough that you don't see each
other at the store so long story short
you both eventually get home open the
door and damn it now there's milk from
your other roommate there because you
both made a decision on this based on
the state of a variable that you
independently examined and you didn't
somehow communicate now in the real
world this is absolutely solvable like
how would you fix this or avoid this
problem in the real world
literally own roommate own fridge
perfect let them know so somehow
communicate and in fact the terminology
here would be multiple threads can
somehow intercommunicate by having
shared State like the iMessage thread on
your phone you could leave a note you
could more dramatically lock the
refrigerator somehow thereby making the
milk purchasing process Atomic the
fundamental problem is that for
efficiency again computers tend to
intermingle logic that needs to happen
when it's happening across multiple
users just for fairness is sake for
scheduling's sake you need to make sure
that all three of these lines of code
execute for me and then for Carter and
then for you if you want to ensure that
this count is correct and for years when
social media was first getting off the
ground this was a super hard problem
Twitter used to go down all of the time
and tweets and retweets were a thing
that were similarly happening with a
very high frequency these are hard
problems to solve and thankfully there
are solutions and we won't get into the
weeds of how you might use these things
but know that there are solutions in the
form of things called locks which I use
that word deliberately with the fridge
software locks can allow you to protect
a variable so no one else can look at it
until you're done with it there are
things called transactions which allow
you to do the equivalent of sending a
message to or really locking out your
roommate from accessing that same
variable too but for slightly less
amount of time there are solutions to
these problems so for instance in Python
the same code now in green might look a
little something like this when you know
that something has to happen all at once
all together you first begin a
transaction and you do your thing and
then you commit the transaction at the
very end here too though there's going
to be a downside typically the more you
use transactions in these way the
potentially the higher the probabilities
that you're going to box someone out or
make Carter's request a little slower
why because we can't interact at the
same time or you might make his request
fail if he tries to update something
that's already been updated so you
generally want to have as few lines of
code together in between these
transactions so that you get in and you
get out and you go to CVS and you get
back really fast so as to not cause
these kind of performance things so
things indeed escalated quickly today
the original goal was just to solve
problems using a different language more
effectively than python but as soon as
you have these more powerful techniques
a whole new set of problems arises takes
practice to get comfortable with but
ultimately this is all leading us toward
the introduction next week of web
programming with HTML CSS and some
JavaScript the week after bringing
Python and SQL back into the mix so that
by terms in we've really now used all of
these different languages for what
they're best at and over the next few
weeks the goal is to make sure you're
understanding and comfortable with what
things each of these things is good and
bad for let's go ahead and wrap here
I'll Stick Around for questions we'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50 and this is already week
eight and if we think back to like the
past several weeks now recall that
things started pretty interestingly
pretty interactively in like week zero
when we were using scratch because with
scratch we had a GUI a graphical user
interface so even as we explored
variables and loops and conditionals and
all of that you had kind of a fun
environment in which to express those
ideas and then in week one we sort of
took a lot of that away when we
introduced c and a terminal window and a
command line because now all of your
programs became very textual uh very
keyboard based and gone was the mouse
the animations the menus and so forth
and so now fast forward to week eight
we're gonna bring those kinds of user
interface UI elements back in the form
of web programming and this goes beyond
just laying out websites this will to
this week and next week combine elements
of the back end server stuff that we've
been doing for the past several weeks
using python using SQL and now
introducing a couple of other languages
on the so-called client side on your own
Mac your own PC your own phone that's
going to talk to those back-end services
so indeed at this end of cs50 does
everything rather come together into a
user interface that's just super
familiar all of us are on our phones
desktops laptops every day and
increasingly even the mobile apps that
you all are using are implemented not
necessarily in languages like Swift or
Java if you're familiar with those but
with languages called HTML CSS and
JavaScript which we'll focus on here
today but before we do that let's kind
of provide a foundation on which these
apps can run because indeed we'll start
to look underneath the hood of how the
internet itself Works albeit quickly so
that we have kind of a mental model for
where all of this code is running how
you can troubleshoot issues and how
really ultimately after cs50 you can
learn by just poking around other actual
websites so the internet we're all on it
literally right now what is it in your
own words
what is the internet
[Music]
it's this utility nowadays that we all
rather take for granted how would you
describe it
okay big storage and indeed that's how
the cloud is described which is kind of
an abstraction if you will for a whole
lot of wires and cables and Hardware
and the internet other formulations of
the term
how else
okay a bunch of data that we can all
reach by way of being interconnected
somehow with wires or wirelessly and so
really the internet too is is a hardware
thing there's a whole lot of servers out
there that are somehow interconnected
via physical cables via internet service
providers via Wireless connectivity and
the like and once you start to have
networks of networks of networks you get
the internet indeed Harvard has its own
network and Yale has its own network and
your own home probably has its own
network but once you start connecting
those networks do you get the
interconnected Network that is the
internet as we now know it so there's
this whole alphabet soup that goes with
the internet some of whose acronyms and
terms you've probably seen before but
let's at least peel back some of those
layers and consider what some of the
building blocks are so here's a picture
of the internet before it was known as
the internet back in 1969 when it was
something called arpanet from the
advanced research projects agency and
the intent originally was just to
interconnect a few universities here in
Utah and California literally servers or
computers on each of those in each of
those areas somehow interconnected with
wires so that people could start to
share data a year later it expanded to
include MIT and Harvard and others and
now fast forward to today you have a
huge number of systems around the world
that are on this same network and in
fact if I just pull up a web page here
that's sort of constantly changing a
visualization of the internet as it
might now be today this here in the
abstract all of these lines and
interconnections represent just how
interconnected the world is today and it
just means that there's all the more
servers all the more cabling all of the
more Hardware giving us this underlying
infrastructure but if we focus really on
just these nodes these individual dots
whether Back in 1970 or now in 2021 each
of these dots you can think of as yes a
server but a certain type of server
namely known as a router and a router as
the name implies just routes data left
to right top to bottom from one point to
another and so there's all these servers
here on campus at Harvard on Yale's
campus in Comcast network for Verizon's
Network your own home network you have
your own routers out there whose purpose
in life is to take in data and then
decide should I send it this way or this
way or this way so to speak assuming
there are multiple options with multiple
cables you and your home probably have
just one cable coming in or going out
but certainly if you're a place like
Harvard or Yale or comcast or the like
there's probably a whole bunch of
interconnect interconnections that the
data can then travel across ultimately
so how do we get data among these
routers for instance if you want to send
an email to someone at Stanford in
California from here on the East Coast
or if you want to visit
www.stanford.edu how does your laptop
your phone your desktop actually get
data from point A to point B well
essentially your laptop or phone knows
when it boots up at the beginning of the
day what the local router is what the
address of that local router is so if
you want to send an email from like my
laptop over here my laptop is
essentially going to hand it to the
nearest Harvard router and then from
there I don't know I don't care how it
gets the rest to the distance but
hopefully within some small number of
steps later Harvard's router is going to
send it to maybe Boston's router is
going to send it to California's router
is going to send it to Stanford's writer
until finally it reaches Stanford's
email server and we can depict this
actually how about a bit playfully
thankfully the course of Staff kindly
volunteer to create a visualization for
this using a familiar technology so here
we have some of our TFS and Tas and Cas
present and passed let me go ahead and
full screen this window here give me
just a moment to pull it up on my screen
here and we'll consider what happens if
we want to send a packet of information
from one person or router namely Phyllis
in this case in the bottom right hand
corner up to Brian in this case in the
top left hand corner so each of the
staff members here represents exactly
one of these routers on the internet
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
my God
the Applause is appreciated it actually
took us a significant number of attempts
to get that ultimately right so when
what was it the staff were all passing
here here we have just physically what
it was the staff were passing around so
Phyllis started with an envelope inside
of which was that email presumably on
the east coast and she wanted to send it
to Brian on the west coast top left-hand
corner and so she had all of these
different options different connections
between her and point B namely Brian she
could go up down uh in her case and then
each of those subsequent routers could
go up down left or right until it
finally reaches Brian and long story
short there's algorithms that figure out
how you decide to send a packet up down
left or right so to speak but they do so
by taking an input and in the form of
input is this envelope and there's at
least a couple of things on the outside
of this because all of these routers and
in turn all of our Macs and PCs and
phones these days speak something called
tcpip a set of acronyms you've probably
seen somewhere on your phone your Mac or
PC and print somewhere which refers to
two protocols two conventions that
computers use to intercommunicate these
days now what's a protocol a protocol is
like a set of rules that you behave in
healthier times I might extend my hand
and someone like Carter might extend his
hand thereby interacting with me based
on a human protocol of like literally
physically shaking hands nowadays we
have mask protocols whereby what you
need to do is wear a mask indoors but
that too is just a set of rules that we
all follow and adhere to that some were
standardized and documented so computers
use protocols all the time to govern how
they are sending information and
receiving information in TCP and IP are
two such protocols that standardize this
as follows what tcpip tells someone like
Phyllis to do is if she wants to send an
email to Brian is put the inmo in a
virtual envelope so to speak but on the
outside of that virtual envelope put
Brian's unique address and I'll describe
this as destination on the middle of the
envelope just like in our human world
you would write the destination address
on the envelope and then she's going to
put her own source address in the top
left hand corner just like you the
sender would put your own source address
in the human world but instead of these
addresses being like something Kirkland
streets Cambridge Massachusetts 02138
USA you probably know that computers on
the internet have unique addresses of
their own known as IP addresses and an
IP address is just a numeric identifier
on the internet that allows computers
like Phyllis and Brian to address these
envelopes to and from each other and
you've probably seen the format at some
point typically the format of IP
addresses is something dot something dot
something dot something each of those
some things represented here with the
hash symbol is a number from zero
through
[Music]
255 and based on that little hint if
each of these hashes represents a number
from 0 to 255 each of those hashes is
represented with how many bytes or bits
eight bits or one byte which is to say
we can extrapolate from that there an IP
address must use 32 bits or 4 bytes if
we rewind now to some of the Primitives
we looked at in week zero and what that
means is at least At a Glance it looks
like we have 4 billion some odd IP
addresses available to us now
unfortunately there's a huge number of
humans in the world these days all of
whom have many of whom have multiple
devices certainly in places like this
where you have a laptop and a phone and
you have other Internet of Things type
devices all of which need to be
addressed so there's another type of IP
address that's starting to be used more
commonly this is version 4 of Ip there's
also version 6 which instead of 32 bits
uses 128 bits which gives us a crazy
number of possible addresses for
computers so we can at least handle all
of the more the additional devices we
now have today so this is to say what
ultimately is going on this envelope is
the destination address that is Brian's
IP address and the source address that
is phyllis's IP address so that this
packet can go from point A to point B
and if need be back by just flipping
this source and the destination but on
the internet you presumably know that
there's not just email servers there's
web servers there's chat servers video
servers Game servers like there's all of
these different functions on the
internet nowadays and so when Brian
receives that envelope how does he know
it's an email versus a uh web page
versus a Skype call versus something
else altogether well it turns out that
we can look at the other part of this
acronym the TCP in tcpip and what TCP
allows us to do for instance is specify
a couple of things one the type of
service whose data is in this envelope
that is it does this with the new a
numeric identifier and I'm going to go
ahead and write down a colon and the
word port p-o-r-t and I'm going to write
that in the source address too colon
import so technically now what's on this
envelope is not just the addresses but
also a unique number that represents
what kind of service has is is being
sent from point A to point B whether
it's email or web traffic or Skype or
something else these numbers are
standardized and here are just two of
the most common ones not even the
context of email but in the context of
the web Port 80 is typically used
whenever an envelope contains a web page
or a request therefore or the number 443
when that request is actually encrypted
using that thing you probably know in
URLs known as https where the S
literally means secure more on what the
http means later if it's email the
number might be 25 or 465 or 587 like
these are the kinds of things you Google
if you ultimately care about but if
you've ever had to configure like
Outlook or even Gmail to talk to another
account you might very well have seen
these numbers by typing in something
like
smtp.gmail.com and then a number which
is only to say these numbers are
omnipresent but they're typically not
things you and I have to care about
because servers and computers nowadays
automate much of this process but that's
all it takes ultimately for Phyllis to
get the this message to Brian
but what if it's a really big message if
it's a short email it might fit
perfectly in one single packet so to
speak but suppose that Phyllis wants to
send Brian a picture of a cat like this
or worse a video of a cat it would be
kind of inequitable if no one else could
do anything on the internet just because
Phyllis wants to send Brian a really big
picture a really big video of a cat it
would be nice if we could kind of
timeshare the interconnections across
these routers so that we can give a
little bit of time to Phyllis a little
bit of time to someone else a little bit
of time to someone else so that
eventually phyllis's entire cat gets
through the internet but in terms of uh
in terms of fairness she doesn't
monopolize the bandwidth of the network
in question and this then allows us to
do one other feature of tcpip which is
fragmentation where we can temporarily
and phyllis's computer would do this
automatically fragment the big packet in
question or the big file in question and
then use not just a single envelope but
maybe a second a third and a fourth or
more
if we do that though we're probably
going to need one other piece of
information just logically on these
envelopes like if you were implementing
this chopping up this picture of a cat
into four parts like intuitively what
might you want to put virtually on the
outside of this envelope now
yeah
the order of them somehow so probably
something like part one of four part two
of four part three of four and so forth
so I'm gonna write one more thing in
like the memo line of the envelope here
I put some kind of sequence number
that's just a little bit of a clue to
Brian to know in what order to
reassemble these things and even more
powerfully than that this actually gives
us this simple primitive of just using
ins on these envelopes in these packets
if Brian receives envelopes like these
with numbers like these in the memo
field what other feature does TCP
apparently enable Brian and Phyllis to
implement this is a bit subtle
but it's not just the ordering of the
packets what else might be useful about
putting numbers on these things might
you think
what might be useful here yeah I'm back
if you missed something that was
intended to be sent if I heard that
correct so shorter answer exactly yes so
TCP because of this simple little
integer that we're including can quote
unquote guarantee delivery why because
if Brian receives one out of four two
out of four four out of four but not
three out of four he now knows
predictably that he needs to ask Phyllis
somehow to resend that packet and so
this is why pretty much always if you
receive an email you either receive the
whole thing or nothing at all like
sentences and words and paragraphs
should never really be missing from an
email or if you download a photograph on
the web it shouldn't just have a blank
hole in the middle just because though
that packet of information happened to
be lost TCP if it is the protocol being
used to transmit data from point A to
point B ensures that it either all gets
there or ultimately none of it at all so
this is an important property but just
as a teaser there's other protocols out
there there's something called UDP which
is an alternative to TCP that doesn't
guarantee delivery and just as a taste
of why you might ever not watch to
guarantee delivery maybe you're watching
like a streaming video like a sports
event online you probably don't
necessarily want the thing to buffer and
buffer and buffer just because you have
a slow connection because you're going
to start to miss things and then you're
going to be only one in the world
watching the game that ended 20 minutes
ago when everyone else is sort of up to
speed similarly for a voice call be
really annoying if our voice is
constantly buffered so UDP might be a
good protocol for making sure that even
if the person on the other end sounds a
little crappy at least you can hear them
it's not pausing and resending and
resending because that would really slow
down that sort of human interaction so
in short IP handles the addressing of
these packets and standardizes numbers
that every computer your own included
gets and TCP handles the standardization
of like what services can be used
uh between points a and point B
all right this is great but presumably
when Phyllis sends a message to Brian
like she doesn't really know and
probably shouldn't care what his IP
address is right these days it's like I
don't know most of the phone numbers
that my friends have I instead look them
up in some way and indeed when you visit
a website what do you type in it's
typically not something not something
not something not something where each
of those somethings is a number what do
you typically type into a browser
so a domain name right something like
stanford.edu harvard.edu yale.edu
gmail.com or any other such domain name
and so thankfully there's another system
on the internet one more acronym for
today called DNS domain name system and
pretty much every Network on the
internet harvards yales Comcast your own
home network somewhere somehow has a DNS
server you probably didn't have to
configure it yourself someone else did
your campus your job your internet
service provider but there's some server
connected somehow to the network you're
on Via wires or wirelessly that just has
a really big table in its memory a big
spreadsheet if you will or if you prefer
a hash table that has at least two
columns of keys and values respectively
where on the left hand side is what
we'll call domain name something like
harvard.edu yale.edu an IP address on
the right hand side that is to say a DNS
server's purpose in life is just to
translate domain names to IP addresses
and vice versa if you want to go in the
other direction and technically just to
be precise it translates fully qualified
domain names to IP addresses and we'll
see what those are in just a moment but
again all of this just kind of happens
magically when you turn on your phone
your laptop today because all of these
things are pre-configured for us
nowadays so how can we actually start to
see some of these things in action
well let's go ahead and and poke around
for instance at a couple of URLs here
let's see what we can actually do now
with these basic Primitives if we now
have the ability to move data from point
A to point B and what can be in that
envelope could be yes an email but today
onward it's really going to be web
content there's going to be content that
you're requesting like give me today's
homepage and there's content you're
sending which would be the contents of
that actual home page and so just to go
one level deeper now that we have these
packets that are getting from point A to
point B using TCP IP let's put something
specific inside of them not just an
email and a bunch of text but something
called HTTP which stands for hypertext
transfer protocol you've seen this for
decades now probably in the form of URLs
so much so that you probably don't even
type it nowadays your browser just adds
it for you automatically and you just
type in harvard.edu or yale.edu or the
like but HTTP is just a final protocol
that we'll talk about here that just
standardizes how web browsers and web
servers intercommunicate so this is a
distinction now between the internet and
the web the internet is really like the
low level Plumbing all of the cables all
of the technology that just moves
packets from left to right right to left
top to bottom that gets data from point
A to point B you can do anything you
want on top of that internet nowadays
email and web and video and chat and
gaming and and all of that so HTTP or
the web is just one application that is
conceptually on top of built on top of
the internet once you take for granted
that there is an internet you can do
really interesting things with it just
like in our physical world once you have
electricity you can just assume you can
do really interesting things with that
too without even knowing or caring how
it works but now that you'll be
programming for the web it's useful to
understand how some of these things
indeed work so let's take a peek at
the format of the things that go inside
of these messages these days it's
usually actually https that's in play
where again the S just means secure more
on that later but the HTTP is what
standardizes what kinds of messages go
inside of these envelopes and
wonderfully it's just textual
information typically there's a simple
text format that humans decided on years
ago that goes inside of these envelopes
that tells a browser how to request
information from a server and how to
respond from the server to that client
with information so here's for instance
a canonical URL https colon slash
www.example.com what might you see at
the end of this you might sometimes see
a slash browsers nowadays kind of
simplify things and don't show it to you
but slash as we'll see just represents
like the default folder the root of the
web server's hard drive like whatever
the base is of it it's like C colon
backslash on Windows or it's uh you know
my computer on Mac OS
but a URL can have more than that it can
have slash path where path is just a
word or multiple words they sort of
describe a longer part of the URL that
path could actually be a specific file
we'll see like something called
file.html more on HTML in just a bit or
it can even be slash folder maybe with
another slash or maybe it can be slash
folder slash file.html now these days
Safari and even Chrome to some extent
and other browsers are in the habit of
trying to hide more in these more and
more of these details from you and I
from you and me ultimately though we'll
it'll be useful to understand what URLs
you're at because it Maps directly to
the code that we're ultimately going to
write but this is only to say that all
this stuff in yellow refers to
presumably a specific file and or folder
on the web server on which you're
programming all right what's this
example.com this is the domain name as
we described it earlier
example.com is the so-called domain name
this whole thing
www.example.com is the fully equal
domain name and what the WW is referring
to is specifically the name of a
specific server in that domain so back
in the day there was a
www.example.com web server there might
have been a mail.example.com mail server
there might have been a chat.example.com
chat server nowadays this host name or
subdomain depending on the context can
actually refer to a whole bunch of
servers right when you go to
www.facebook.com that's not one server
that's thousands of servers nowadays so
long story short there's technology that
somehow get your data to one of those
servers but this whole thing is what we
meant by fully qualified domain name
this thing here hostname in the context
of an email address it might
alternatively be called a sub domain
this thing here top level domain
probably know that.com means commercial
although anyone can buy it these
days.org similar.net some of them are a
bit restricted dot mil is just for the
US military.edu is just for credit
educational institutions but there are
hundreds if not more top level domains
nowadays some more popular than others
cs50s tools for instance use cs50.io IO
sort of connotes input output it
actually is a belongs though to a small
island nation a country whose country
code is dot IO and you see other two
letter uh top level domains that are
country specific indeed uh it's
something.uk something.jp and the like
typically refer to countries but some of
them have been rather co-opted dot TV as
well because they have these meanings in
English as well lastly this is what
we'll call the protocol that specifies
how the server uses this URL to get data
from point A to point B so what is
inside of this envelope let's now start
poking around a little bit more what is
inside of this envelope it's essentially
for our purposes today one of two verbs
either get or post and any of you have
dabbled with HTML or made your own
website you might have seen some of
these terms before but these two verbs
describe drive just how to send
information from you to the server long
story short more on this next week get
means put any user input in the URL post
means hide it so that things you're
searching for credit card numbers you're
typing in usernames and passwords are
inputting don't show up in the URL and
are therefore visible to anyone with
access to your computer in your search
history but rather they're somehow
provided elsewhere deeper into that
envelope but for now we'll focus almost
entirely on get which is perhaps the
most common one that we're always going
to use and what we're going to do is
this let me switch over just to a blank
screen here and if we assume that little
old me is this laptop here
and I'm connected to the cloud and in
that cloud is some server that I want to
request the webpage of harvard.edu or
yale.edu it's really going to be a
two-step process there's going to be a
request that goes from point A to point
B and then hopefully the server that
hears that request is going to reply
with what we'll typically call a
response and other terms that are
relevant here is my laptop is the
so-called client harvard.edu yale.edu
whatever it is is the so-called server
and just like in a restaurant where you
might request something to eat the
server might bring it to you it's again
that kind of bi-directional relationship
one request one response for each such
web page we request
all right so what's inside these
envelopes and what do we actually see
well this Arrow this line I just drew
from left to right representing their
request technically looks a little more
like this
when you visit a web page using your
browser on your phone laptop or desktop
what's going inside that envelope and
the textual message your Mac or PC or
phone is automatically generating looks
a little something like this the verb
get the URL or rather the path that you
want to get slash represents the default
page on the website HTTP 1.1 is just
some mention of what version of HTTP
you're speaking now we're up to versions
two and version three but 1.1 is quite
common and the envelope contains some
mention of the host that was typed in
the fully qualified domain name this is
because single servers can actually host
many different websites if you're using
Squarespace or Wix or one of these
popular hosting websites nowadays you
don't get your own personal server most
likely you're on the same server as
dozens hundreds of other customers but
when your customers your users browsers
include a little mention of your
specific fully qualified domain name in
the envelope Squarespace and Wix just
know to send it to your web page or my
webpage or or some other customer
altogether dot dot dot there's some
other stuff there but
that sense of what's in these response
requests
hopefully then when your browser
requests this webpage from the server
what comes back well hopefully a
response that looks like this HTTP 1.1
so the same version some status code
like a number 200 and then literally a
short phrase like okay which means
exactly that like okay this request was
satisfied then it contains some other
information like the type of content
that's coming back and we'll see that
this too is standardized text HTML means
here comes some HTML which is just a
text language it could instead be image
slash jpeg or image slash ping or video
slash MP4 there are these different
content types otherwise known as mime
types that uniquely identify types of
files that come back similar in spirit
to file extensions but a little more
standardized this way then there's more
some more stuff dot dot but in general
what you see here are our familiar
pattern keys and values these keys and
values are otherwise known as HTTP
headers and your browser has been
sending these every time you visit a
website and indeed we can see this right
now ourselves let me go over in just a
second to Chrome on my computer though
you can do this kind of thing with most
any browser today I'll go ahead and
visit HTTP colon slash harvard.edu enter
and voila I'm Ed Harvard's homepage for
today the content often changes but this
is what it looks like right now well I
typed in the URL but notice it changed a
little bit it actually sent me to https
and it added www even though I didn't
type that but it turns out we can poke
around at what my browser is actually
doing let me open another page and I'm
going to start to use incognito mode
this time not because I care that people
know I'm visiting harvard.edu but
because it throws away any history that
I just did so that every request is
going to look like a brand new one and
that's just useful diagnostically
because we're always going to see fresh
information my browser's not going to
remember what I previously already
requested but I'm going to go up to view
developer developer tools which is
something that all of you have if you
use Chrome and there's something
analogous for Firefox and Edge and
Safari and other browsers developer
tools is going to open up these tabs
down here I don't really care what's new
so I'm going to close the bottom thing
there and I'm going to hover over the
network tab for just a moment and now
I'm going to go and say HTTP colon slash
harvard.edu so the shorter version I'm
going to hit enter
and a whole bunch of stuff just flew
across the screen and it's still coming
in and if I zoom in down here my God
visiting harvard.edu still going is
downloading what 17 18 19 megabytes 20
megabytes millions of bytes of
information over 111 HTTP requests in
other words a bit of a simplification
but my browser unbeknownst to me sent
one envelope initially with the request
then the server said okay by the way
there's 110 other things you need 112
other things you need to get so my
computer went back and forth requesting
even more content for me why well inside
of Harvard's web page is a whole bunch
of images and maybe sound files and
videos and other stuff that all need to
be downloaded and to compose what is
ultimately the web page but I don't care
about like 100 plus of these things
let's focus on the very first one first
the very first request I sent was up
here and I'm going to click on this row
under the network Tab and then I'm going
to see a bit of diagnostic information
to an average person using the web they
needn't care about this just as you
probably didn't care about until right
now and even then perhaps not but if I
scroll down to request headers you will
see if I click view Source literally
everything that was in the request my
Mac just sent to harvard.edu two of the
lines are familiar get slash HTTP 1.1
host colonharvard.edu and then other
stuff that for now it's not that
interesting for us but let's look at the
response that came back from the server
I'm going to scroll up now
and see response headers view source and
this is interesting it is not okay
there's no 200 there's no word okay
curiously harvard.edu has moved
permanently
what does that mean well there's a whole
bunch of stuff here that's not that
interesting for us but this line
location is interesting this is an HTTP
header a standardized key value pair
that's part of the HTTP protocol that is
conventions and if I highlight just this
one it's telling me Harvard is not a
HTTP colon harvard.edu Harvard's website
is now and perhaps Forever at https
colon
www.harvard.edu so what's the value here
probably someone at Harvard wants you to
use a secure connection so they
redirected you from HTTP to https maybe
the marketing people want you to be at
www instead of justharvard.edui just to
standardize things but there are
technical reasons to use a host name and
not just the raw domain name and all
this other stuff is sort of
uninteresting for our purposes now
because a browser that receives a 301
response Knows by design by the
definition of HTTP to automatically
redirect the user and that's why in my
browser all of this happened in like a
split second because I didn't really
know or care about all of those headers
but that's why and how I ended up at
this URL here my browser was told to go
elsewhere via that new location and the
browser just followed those breadcrumbs
if you will at which point it downloaded
all of the other images and files and so
forth that compose
this particular page
well let me let me zoom out and let me
actually go into vs code if only because
it's a little more pleasant to do things
in just a terminal window without
actually using a full-fledged browser so
now let's just use an equivalent program
it's called curl for connecting to a URL
that's going to allow me to play with
websites and just see those headers
without bothering to download all the
images and text and so forth from the
website it's going to allow me to do
something like this let me go ahead and
run for instance curl Dash I Dash X get
which is just the command line argument
that says simulate a get request
textually as though you're a browser and
let's go to http colon slash
harvard.edu enter now by way of how curl
works I'm just seeing the headers it
didn't bother downloading the whole
website and you see exactly the same
thing 301 move permanently location is
indeed this one here so that's kind of
interesting but let's follow it manually
now let's now do what it's telling me to
do let's go to the location with https
and the www and hit enter and now
what's a good sign with this output most
of it's irrelevant
200 okay that means I'm seeing
presumably if I were using a real
browser the actual content of the web
page looks like Harvard's version of
HTTP is even newer than my the one I'm
using it's using HTTP version 2 which is
fine but 200 is indeed indicative of
things being okay well what if I try
visiting some bogus URL like harvard.edu
and this file does not exist something
completely random probably doesn't exist
and hit enter
what do you see now that's perhaps
familiar in the real world yeah
yeah error 404 all of us have seen this
probably endlessly from time to time
when you screw up by mistyping a URL or
someone deletes the web page in question
but all that is is a status code that a
browser is being sent from the server
that's a little clue as to what the
actual problem is underneath the hood so
instead of getting back for instance
something like okay or move permanently
what I've just gotten back quite simply
is 404 not found well it turns out
there's other types of status codes that
you'll start to see over time as you
start to program for the web 200 is okay
301 is moved permanently 302 304 307 are
all similar in spirit they're related to
redirecting the user from one place to
another
401 403
unauthorized or forbidden if you ever
mess up your password or you try
visiting a URL you're not supposed to
look at you might see one of these codes
indicating that you just don't have
authorization for those 404 not found
418 I'm a teapot was a April Fool's joke
by the community Tech Community years
ago 500 is bad and unfortunately all of
you are probably on a path now to
creating HTTP 500 errors once next week
we start writing code because all of us
are going to screw up we're going to
have typos logical errors and this is on
the horizon just like seg faults were in
the world of C but solvable with the
right skills 503 service unavailable
means maybe the server is overloaded or
something like that and there's other
codes there but those are perhaps some
of the most common ones
um has anyone I can we can get away with
this here less so in New Haven has
anyone um ever visited uh
safetyschool.org
HTTP colon slash slash safety School dot
org there we do this enter
oh look at that where did we end up
Okay so
so this has been like a joke for like 10
or 20 years someone out there has been
paying for the domain name
safetyschool.org just for this two
second demonstration but we can now
infer how did this work the person who
bought that domain name and somehow
configured DNS to point to like their
web server the IP address of their web
server what is their web server
presumably spitting out whenever a
browser requests the page
what status code perhaps well we can
simulate this let me go over to vs code
let me go back over here let me increase
my terminal window let me do curl Dash I
Dash X get HTTP colon slash safe T
School dot org enter and that's all this
website does there's not even an actual
website there no HTML no CSS languages
we're about to see it literally just
exists on the internet to do that
redirect there in fairness
um there are others let me actually do
another one here instead of
safetyschool.org
turns out someone some years ago bought
Harvard sucks dot org enter
and when we do this you'll see that oh I
they don't need us to be secure but I do
need the the www let's do this one enter
oh that one is not found this demo
actually worked for so many years but
someone has stopped paying for the
Squarespace discount recently apparently
so
okay
so fortunately we did save the YouTube
video to which this thing refers and so
just to put this into context since it's
been quite a few years Harvard and Yale
of course have this long-standing
rivalry uh there is this tradition of
pranking each other and honestly hands
down one of the best pranks ever done in
this rival was by Yale to Harvard it's
about a three minute retrospective it's
one of the earliest videos I dare say on
YouTube so the quality is uh
representative of that but let me go
ahead and full screen my you my page
here and what used to live at
harvardsucks.org is this video here if
we could dim the lights for about three
minutes
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
pass them down
[Music]
[Applause]
we're nice
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think of Yale they don't
think good
dude
is there another stuff
[Music]
what houses sometimes
[Applause]
all right now
[Music]
[Applause]
one more time
oh there it goes again
[Applause]
all right so thanks to our friends at
Yale for that one
let's go ahead here and consider in just
a moment what further is deeper down
inside of the envelope because we now
have the ability to get data from oh
okay oh YouTube autoplay again gotta
stop doing that let's consider for just
a moment that
let's consider for just a moment that we
now have this ability to get data from
point A to point B and we have the
ability to specify in those envelopes
what it is we want from the website we
want to get the home page we want to get
back the HTML but what is that HTML in
fact we don't yet have the language with
which the web pages themselves are
written namely HTML and CSS but let's go
ahead and take a five minute break here
and when we come back we'll learn those
two languages
all right we are back so we got three
languages to look at today but two of
them are not actually programming
languages what makes something a
programming language like C or Python
and SQL is that there are these
contracts via which you can express
conditionals you might have variables
you might have looping constructs you
have the ability ultimately to express
logic HTML and CSS aren't so much about
logic as they are about structure and
the Aesthetics of a page and so we're
going to create like the skeleton of a
web page using this pair of languages
HTML and CSS and then toward the end of
the today we'll introduce an actual
programming language that actually is
pretty similar in spirit and
syntactically to both C and python but
that's going to allow us to make these
web pages not just static things that
you look at but interactive applications
as well and then next week again in week
nine will we reintroduce Python and SQL
tie all of this together so that you can
actually have a browser or a phone
talking to a back-end server and
creating the experience that you and I
now take for granted for most any app or
website today well let's go ahead and do
this let's quickly whip up something in
this language called HTML I'm in vs code
here I'm going to go ahead and create a
file quite simply called
hello.html the convention is typically
to end your file names in HTML and I'm
going to go ahead and bang this out real
quick but then we'll more slowly step
through what the constructs are here in
so I'm going to say Doc type HTML Open
Bracket HTML and then notice I'm going
to do Open Bracket slash HTML close
bracket and I'm leveraging a feature of
vs code and programming environments
more generally to do a bit of
autocomplete so you'll see that there's
this symmetry to much of what I'm going
to type but I'm not typing all of these
things vs code is automatically
generating the end of my thought for me
if you if you will let me go ahead and
say uh open the head tag open the title
tag I'll say something cute like hello
title and then down here I'm going to
create the body of this web page and say
something like hello body and let me
specify at the very top that all of this
is really in English Lang equals Yen so
at this moment I have a file in my vs
code environment called hello.html vs
code as we're using it of course is
cloud-based we're using it in a browser
even though you can also download it and
run it on a Mac and PC so we're kind of
in this weird situation where I'm using
the cloud to create a web page and I
want that web page to also live in the
cloud that is on the internet
but the thing about vs code or really
any website that you might use in a
browser by default that website is using
probably TCP port number 80 or TCP port
number 443 which is HTTP and https
respectively but here I am sort of a
programmer myself trying to create my
own website on an existing website so
it's a bit of a weird situation but
that's okay because what's nice about
TCP is that you and I can just pick port
numbers to use and run our own web
server on a web server that is we can
control the environment entirely by just
running our own web server via this
command HTTP
server in my terminal window this is a
command that we pre-installed in vs code
here and you'll notice a pop-up just
came up your application running on port
8080 is available that's a commonly used
TCP port number when 80 is already used
and 443 is already used you can run your
own server on your own port 8080 in this
case I've opened that tab in advance and
if I go into another browser tab here
here I see a so-called directory listing
of the web server I'm running so I don't
see any of my other files I don't see
anything belonging to vs code itself I
only see the file that I've created in
my current directory called hello.html
and so if I click on this file now I
should see Hello body I don't see the
title but that's because the title of a
web page nowadays is typically embedded
in the tab and if I'm full screen in my
browser there are no tabs so let me
minimize the window a bit and now you
can see just in this single browser
window and my own URL here that hello
body is in the top left hand corner and
if I zoom in there's hello title so what
have I done here I have gone ahead and
created my own web page in HTML in a
file called
hello.html and then I have opened up
a web server of my own configured it to
listen on TCP port 8080 which just says
to the internet Hey listen for requests
from web browsers not on the standard
port number 80 or 443 listen on 8080 and
this means I can develop a website using
a web-based tool like this one here
which is increasingly common today all
right so now let's consider what it is I
actually just typed out HTML is
characterized really by just two
features two vocab words tags and
attributes most of what I just typed
were tags but there was at least one
attribute already here's the same source
code that I typed out in HTML from top
to bottom let's consider what this is
the very first line of code here doctype
HTML is the only anomalous one it's the
only one that starts with an Open
Bracket a less than sign and an
exclamation point there's no more
exclamation points thereafter for now
this is the document type declaration
which is a fancy way of saying it's just
got to be there nowadays it's like a
little breadcrumb at the beginning of a
file that says to the browser I am you
are about to see a file written in HTML
version in five that line of code has
changed over time over the years the
most recent version of it is nice and
succinct like this and it's just a clue
to the browser as to what version of
HTML is being used by you the programmer
all right what comes after that well
after that and I've highlighted two
things in yellow this is what we're
going to start calling an open tag or a
start tag Open Bracket HTML then
something close bracket is the so-called
start or open tag then the corresponding
close or end tag is down here and it's
almost the same you use the same tag
number use the same angle bracket but
you do add a slash and you don't repeat
yourself with any of the things called
attributes because what is this thing
here Lang equals quote unquote en means
the language of my page is written in
the English language the humans have
standardized two and three letter codes
for every human language right now and
so this is just a clue to the browser
for like automatic translation and
accessibility purposes what language the
web page itself is and not the tags but
the words like hello title and hello
body which while minimalists are indeed
in English so when you close a tag you
close the name of it with the Slash and
the angle brackets you don't repeat the
attribute that would just be annoying to
have to type everything again but notice
the pattern here it's new syntax but
this is another example of key value
pairs in Computing the key is Lang the
value is en for English the attribute is
called Lang the value is called it is en
so again it's just key value Pairs and
just yet another context probably the
browser is using a hash table underneath
the hood to keep track of this stuff
like a two column table with keys and
values again humans keep using the same
Paradigm in different languages what's
inside of that the nesting is important
visually not to the computer but to us
the humans because it implies that
there's some hierarchy here and indeed
what is inside of the HTML tag here well
we have what we'll call the head tag the
head tag says Hey browser here comes the
head of the page and then the body tag
says Hey browser here comes the body of
the page the body is like 99 of the
user's experience the big rectangular
window the head is really just the
address bar and other such stuff at top
like the title that we saw a moment ago
just to introduce the vernacular then
the HTML tag otherwise known as an
element has two children the head child
and the body child which is to say that
head and body are now siblings so you
can use the same kind of family tree
terminology that we used when talking
about trees weeks ago if we look at the
head tag how many children does it seem
to have
I'm saying one and indeed at least if we
ignore all the white space the the
spaces or tabs or new line characters
there's just one child a title element
and an element is the terminology that
includes the start tag and the end tag
and everything in between so this is the
title element and the title element has
one child which is just pure text
otherwise known as a text node recall
node from our discussions of data
structures weeks ago if we jump into the
body which is the other child of the
HTML tag it too has one child which is
just another chunk of text a text node
that says quote unquote hello body
what's nice about this indentation even
though the browser technically is not
going to care is that it implies this
kind of structure and this is where we
connect like weeks five and now weeks
eight here is the tree structure we
began to talk about even in our world of
C it's not a binary tree even though
this one happens to have no more than
two children it's an arbitrary tree that
can have zero or any number of children
but if we have a special note here that
refers to the document the root node so
to speak is HTML drawn with a rectangle
here just for discussion sake it has two
children head and body also rectangles
head has a title child and then it and
body have text nodes which I've drawn
with ovals instead which is only to say
that when your browser Chrome Safari
whatever downloads a web page opens up
that envelope and sees the contents that
have come back from the server it
essentially reads the code that someone
wrote the HTML code top to bottom left
to right and creates in the browser's
memory in your Mac or your PC or your
phone's memory or Ram this kind of data
structure that's what's going on
underneath the hood and that's why
aesthetically it's just nice as a human
to indent things stylistically because
it's very clear then to you and to other
programmers what's the structure
actually is so that's it for like the
fundamentals of HTML we'll see a bunch
of tags and a bunch of examples now but
HTML is just tags and attributes and
it's the kind of thing that you look
them up when you need to eventually many
of them get ingrained I constantly
checked the reference guides or stack
Overflow if I'm trying to figure out how
do I lay something out it's really just
these building blocks that allow you to
assemble the structure of a web page
this one's being super simple but it's
just tags and attributes any questions
on this framework before we start to add
more tags more vocabulary if you will
and in the middle yeah
[Music]
if we put the Tello tag around body uh
that's a good question let's try it so
let me actually go to
uh this and say Open Bracket title
whoops sometimes you don't want it to
finish your thought for you but it did
that time I've gone ahead and uh changed
the file let me go and open up give me a
second to open my terminal window and go
back to the URL that has my page
give me a second
there's my hello.html let me zoom in on
this let me zoom in on this and let me
go ahead now and click on hello.html
and in this case it looks like we don't
actually see anything so the browser is
hiding it technically speaking
browsers tend to be pretty generous and
half the time when you make mistakes in
HTML it will display it might display
not display as you intended it might not
display the same on Macs or PCS or
Chrome or on Firefox there is a tool
though that we'll see that can help
answer this question for you for
instance if I go to
validator.w3.org W3 is the worldwide Web
Consortium a group of people that
standardize this kind of stuff I can
click on validate by direct input and
just copy paste my sample HTML into this
box and click check and I should see
hopefully that indeed it's an error what
you propose that I do the browser just
did its best to do something which was
to show me nothing at least rather than
the incorrect information but if I
revert that change and let me undo what
we just did let me copy my original code
back into this text box and click check
now you can see conversely my code is
now correct and there's automated tools
to check that but we'll encourage you
for problem sets and projects to use
that particular manual tool all right so
let's go ahead and enhance this a little
bit by introducing whole bunch of tags
just to give you a sense of some of the
building blocks here so I'm going to go
ahead and create a new file called
paragraphs.html and I'm just going to do
a bunch of copy paste just to start
things off so I'm not constantly typing
all this darn stuff again and again
because I want everything to be the same
here except I'm going to change my title
to be paragraphs for this demo and
inside of the body I need a whole bunch
of paragraphs of text and I don't really
want to come up with some text so let me
go to some random website here and grab
lorem ipsum text which if you're
involved in like student newspaper or
just design this is just placeholder
text kind of looks like Latin but
technically isn't here though I have a
handy way of just getting three long
paragraphs and something that looks like
Latin and I've put those notice inside
of the body and they're indeed long look
how long the uh the made up words here
are so let me go now into my
browser
tab here
let me reload this page and you'll see
two files have now appeared
paragraphs.html which is my new one and
hello.html let me click on
paragraphs.html and what clearly seems
to be wrong
yeah
yeah it's obviously one massive
paragraph instead of three so that's
interesting but it's just a little hint
as to how pedantic HTML is it will only
do what you say in each of these tags
tells the browser to start doing
something and then maybe stop doing
something like hey browser here comes my
HTML hey browser here comes the head of
my page hey browser here comes the title
of my page hello title hey browser
that's it for the title that's it for
the head here comes the body tag so it's
kind of having this conversation between
the browser between the HTML and the
browser doing literally what it says so
if you want to paragraph you're probably
going to want to use the P tag for
paragraph and I'm going to go ahead and
add this to my code I'm going to keep
things neat even though the browser
won't care by indenting things here let
me create another paragraph tag here
and close it right after that one
indenting again and I'm keeping
everything nice and orderly let me do
one more here
let me indent that and then let me add
it to the end of my page here
so again a little tedious but now I have
three paragraphs of text that say Hey
browser start a paragraph hey browser
stop that paragraph start stop and so
forth let me go back to the browser
window here let me hit command r or
control R to reload the page and voila
now I have three cleaner paragraphs all
right so there's a P tag for paragraphs
so now we have that particular building
block what if I want to add for instance
some headings to this page well that's
something that's possible too let me go
ahead and create a new file called
headings.html let me copy and paste that
same code as before but now let's
preface each paragraph with maybe H1 and
I'm going to just write the word one
and here I'm going to say H2 2 and down
here I might say h33 so this is another
tag another three tags H1 H2 H3 as you
might have inferred by the file name I
chose this gives you headings like in a
chat in a book different chapters or
sections or subsections or in an
academic paper you have different
hierarchies to the text that you're
writing so now that I've added an H1 tag
and the word one h2 tag the word two H3
tag and the word three let's go back to
the browser reload the page again and
voila
once the page reloads
I'll do it with the manual button reload
the page
oh what am I doing wrong
yeah
I'm right I'm not in the headings file
so let me go back a page now there's
headings.html let me click on that okay
now we see some evidence of this again
it's nonsensical content but you can
kind of see that H1 is apparently big
and bold H2 is slightly less big but
still bold H3 is the same but a little
smaller and it goes all the way down to
H6 after that you should probably
reorganize your thoughts but there's six
different hierarchies here as you might
use for chapters sections subsections
and so forth all right so those are
headings as an HTML tag in our
vocabulary what's a common thing too
well let me go to
uh vs code again let me go ahead and get
some boilerplate here create a file
called
list.html let's create a simple list
inside of my body and I'll give this a
title of a list and let me fix the title
of this one to be headings as well so in
list.html suppose I want to have a list
of things uh Foo bar and baz or like a
computer scientist go to words just like
a mathematician might say XYZ fubarbaz
is in list.html let me go back to my
browser
hit the back button there's list.html
and hopefully I'll see Foo bar and baz
one on each line like a nice little list
but of course I do not and this is not
English Chrome thinks it might be Arabic
but that's
um curious too because the Lang
attribute should be overriding that so
Google is trying to override it all
right what's the obvious explanation why
we're seeing Fubar and Bez on the same
line and not three separate ones
we didn't tell it to do that so we need
paragraph tags or maybe something else
turns out there is something else there
is a UL tag for an unordered list in
HTML inside of which you can have Li
tags for list item inside of which you
can put your words so there's my Foo
there's my bar there's my baz and again
notice that vs code is finishing my
thought for me but notice the hierarchy
open UL openli close Li open Li close Li
open Li close Li close UL so what it's
sort of done in reverse order here let
me go back to my browser reload the same
page list.html and voila a default
bulleted list that still seems to be in
Arabic what if I want this list to be
numbered well you can probably guess if
you don't want an unordered list but an
ordered list what type should I use
[Music]
oh well sure so let's try that's not
always that easy as just guessing but in
this case ol is going to do the trick
let me go back to my other browser let
me reload the page and now it's going to
automatically number for me it's a tiny
thing but this is actually useful if you
have a very long list of data and maybe
you might add some things in the middle
the beginning or the edit would just be
annoying to have to go and renumber it
the computer is doing it for us by
instead just a numbering from top to
bottom here all right what about another
type of layout not just paragraphs not
just lists but what about tabular data
you've got some research data you want
to present some financial data you want
to present a phone book that you want to
present how might we go about laying out
data a la a table well let me create a
file called table.html
and I'll just copy paste where we
started earlier let me start to close
some of these other files and in
table.html this is going to be a bit
more HTML but I'm going to go ahead and
do this table and close table tables can
have table headings so T head is the
name of that tag and tables can have t
bodies table bodies so I'm going to add
that tag and this is a common technique
sort of start your thought finish your
thought and then go back and fill in
what's in between what do I want to put
in this table how about a bunch of names
and numbers so for instance like left
column name right column number so let's
create a table row with What's called
the TR tag let's create a table heading
with the th tag and let's say name here
let's create another table heading
called number here and all of that to be
clear is in one table row meanwhile in
the table body let me create another
table row but this time it's not a
heading now I'm in the guts of my table
let's do table data which is synonym
with like the cell of the table in uh
like an Excel spreadsheet or Google
spreadsheet in this TD I'm going to say
like Carter's name and then let's you
grab Carter's number from our past demo
617-495-1000 then let's put me into the
mix and I'll go ahead and copy paste
here which often is not good but we'll
see that there's a lot of shared
structure with HTML let me go ahead and
do mine
949-468-2750 and now save this page so
we're getting to be a lot of indentation
I'm using four spaces by default some
people use two spaces by default so long
as you're consistent that's considered
good style but let me go back to my
browser here and hit back
that then brings me to my directory
listing again here's table.html and this
is not that interesting yet but you can
see that there's two columns name and
number because it's a table heading th
the browser made it bold-faced for me in
their in the table or two rows below
that Carter and David it's a little oh I
forgot my number one sorry about that
one and one it's not the prettiest table
right I feel like I kind of want to
separate things a little more maybe put
some Borders or the like but with HTML
alone I'm really focusing on the
structure alone so we'll make this
prettier soon but for now this is how
you might lay out tabular data all right
let me pause here just to see if there's
any questions but again the goal right
now is just to kind of throw at you some
basic building blocks that again can be
easily looked up in a reference but
we're going to start stylizing these
things soon too
and yeah in the middle
how do you indent paragraphs really good
question for that we're probably going
to want something called CSS cascading
style sheets so let me come back to that
in just a little bit for the stylization
of these things beyond the basics like
big and bold we're going to need a
different language all together
all right well let's now create what the
web is full of which is uh like
photographs and images and the like let
me go ahead and create a new file called
image.html and let me go ahead and
change the title here to be say image
and then in the body of this page let's
go ahead and put an image the
interesting thing about an image is that
it's actually not going to have a start
tag and an end tag because that's kind
of illogical like how can you start an
image and then eventually finish it it's
either there or It Isn't So some tags do
not have n tags so let me do image IMG
Source equals
harvard.jpg and let me go ahead and in
my terminal window I actually came with
a photo of Harvard let me grab this for
just a second
uh let me grab harvard.jpg and put it
into my directory pretend that I
downloaded that in advance and so I'm
referring to now a file called
harvard.jpg that apparently is in the
same folder as my image.html file if
this image were on the internet like
Harvard server I could also say like
https colon slash
www.harbor.edu folder name whatever it
is slash harvard.jpg but if you've in
advance uploaded a file to your own vs
code environment like I did before class
by dragging and dropping this full file
this photo of Harvard you can just refer
to it relatively so to speak this would
be the same thing as saying dot slash
harvard.jpg go to the current directory
and get the file called harvard.jpg but
that's unnecessary to type for
accessibility purposes though for
someone who's vision impaired it's ideal
if we also give this an alternative text
something like Harvard University and
the so-called alt tag and this is so
that screen readers will recite what it
is the photo is for folks who can't see
it and if you're just on a slow
connection sometimes you'll see the text
of what you're about to see before the
image itself downloads especially on a
mobile device so let's now go back to my
open browser tab
and let's look in the directory I now
have harvard.jpg which I downloaded in
advance and image.html let me click on
image.html and here we have a really big
picture of Memorial Hall the building
we're currently in suffice it to say I
should probably fix this and maybe make
it only so wide but to do that we're
going to probably want to use this other
language CSS there are some historical
attributes that you can still use to
control width and height and so forth
but we're going to do it the better way
so to speak with a language designed for
just that how about a video though I
also came prepared with let me grab
another file here let me grab a file
called uh
halloween.mp4 which is an MPEG file and
let me go ahead and
change this now to be a file called
video.html I'll change my title to be
video and let's go ahead and now
introduce another tag a video tag Open
Bracket video and then let me go ahead
and close that tag proactively and then
inside of the video tag you can say the
source of the video is going to be
specifically Halloween dot MP4 the type
of this file I know is video slash MP4
because I looked up its content type or
mime type and the video tag actually has
a few attributes I can have this thing
auto play I can have it Loop forever I
can mute it so that there's no sound
which is necessary nowadays most
browsers to prevent ads don't auto play
videos if they have sound so if you mute
your video it will auto play but
presumably not annoy users and let me
set the width of this thing to be like
oh 1280 pixels wide but I can make it
any size I want so I know this just from
having you know looked up the Syntax for
this tag but notice one curiosity
sometimes attribute don't have values
they're empty attributes they're just
single words autoplay Loop muted and
that kind of makes sense for any
attribute that really does what it says
like it doesn't make sense to say muted
equals something like it's either muted
or not the attribute is there or not
similarly for these others as well so
let me go back to my other browser tab
reload the directory listing there is
both my mp4 and also video.html which is
the web page that embeds it and this is
actually a video that was just on
Harvard's website last yesterday and it
was amazing so we included it in this
demo here
this is the video that was on
harvard.edu last night
same photo but you can see here that an
image alone probably would not have the
same effect this is actually a movie a
small video file that's now looping now
there's some artifacts here like there's
a white border around the top I feel
like it'd be nice to fill the screen but
again we'll come back to a language that
can allow us to do exactly that well
it's not just videos like this that you
might want to put into a web page let me
create another file called
iframe.html if you've ever poked around
with it if you have your own YouTube
account or you had your own blog or
WordPress site or Wix or Squarespace you
might have been in the habit of
embedding videos in websites using like
embedded YouTube players well this is
possible too using what's called an
inline frame an iframe and an iframe is
just a tag that is literally iframe it
has Source equals and then a URL and if
it happens to be a YouTube video there's
a certain URL format you need to follow
per YouTube's documentation so you might
do
www.youtube.com embed and then here's an
ID of a video
uh so this is essentially what we do if
we want to embed uh cs50's own lecture
videos in the course's website or the
video player does literally this if I
want to allow full screen I can add this
attribute to that I know exists by just
having checked the documentation and if
I now go back to my browser here
reload my directory listing there's
iframe.html it's not going to fill the
screen because I haven't customized the
Aesthetics yet but it does seem to embed
a tiny little video there for for you to
play with later if you'd like so we
could change the width change the height
get rid of that margin and so forth but
an iframe is a way of embedding someone
else's web page in your web page if they
allow it so as to create all the more of
an interactive experience for them on
say your site all right well let what
the web is of course known for things
like links let's go ahead and create a
file called
link.html and if we want to create a web
page that actually links from itself
somewhere else let's go ahead and do
this something very simple like visit
Harvard
dot edu period now in like Facebook
Instagram a lot of websites nowadays if
you just type in a domain name or a
fully qualified domain name it
automatically becomes a link that's
because those websites have code in them
that automatically detect something that
looks like a URL and turns it into a
proper link HTML itself does not do that
for you and so if I go back to my web
page here click on link.html if you type
visit harvard.edu period that's all
you're literally going to see but
instinctively even if you've never
written HTML before what should we
probably do here to solve this problem
[Music]
what could we do to solve this problem
what do I probably want to add yeah
yeah so I want to surround the URL with
some kind of Link text and you wouldn't
necessarily know this until someone told
you or you looked it up but the tag for
creating a link is somewhat weirdly
called the a tag for anchor it has an
attribute called href for hyper
reference which is like a link in the
virtual world to a URL so let me type in
Harvard's full and proper URL here then
I'm going to close the tag
and then I can still say harvard.edu and
make that what the human sees but the
place they're going to go should be a
full URL protocol and all HTTP or https
and all now if I go back here and reload
the page now it automatically gets
underlined it happens to be purple by
default why because we visited
harvard.edu a few minutes ago so my
browser by default is indicating in
purple that I've been there before but
now I have a link that I can click on
and if I hover over it but don't click
you'll see that in most browsers there's
a little clue as to where you will go if
you click subsequently on this link and
without going too far down a rabbit hole
but to tie together our discussion of
cyber security recently what if I were
to do something like this
right now you have the beginnings of a
phishing attack of sorts
p-h-i-s-h-i-n-g whereby you can create
clearly a web page or heck even an email
using HTML that tells the user they're
going to go one place but they're really
going to go someplace else altogether
and that is the essence of phishing
attacks these days if you've ever gotten
a bogus email pretending to be from
PayPal or your bank or some other
website odds are they've just written
HTML that says whatever they want but
the underlying tags might do something
very different and so having the
instinct to look in the bottom left-hand
corner or be a little suspicious when
you're just told blindly to click on a
link it's this easy to socially engineer
people that is deceive them by just
saying one thing and linking to another
well what if I want to link my page to
another page I already created well if I
want to link to like that photo of
Harvard I can just do href equals quote
unquote in the name of a file in my same
account that is itself a web page so
this is how you can create relative
links a multi-page web pages multi-page
websites yourself so if I now reload
this page hover overharbor.edu you'll
see in the bottom left hand corner a
very long URL but that's because I'm in
code spaces right now vs code and it's
appending automatically to the end of my
current URL the file name image.html but
this should work when I click on this I
go immediately to that file we created
earlier with a crazy big version of the
image but that's just a way that one
page on a website can link to another
page on a website
let's do one other thing here uh making
things more responsive because in fact
that wasn't a particularly responsive
website responsive means responding to
the size of the user's device which is
so important when someone might be on a
screen like this or on a screen like
this these days there are special tags
we can use to tell the browser to modify
its display based on the hardware so let
me create a file called responsive.html
I'm going to copy paste some and
starting point here call this title
responsive and let me go ahead and just
grab let me grab some of that lorem
ipsum text from before just so that we
have a sizable paragraph to play with
here and let me go ahead and grab this
text here
and I'm just going to paste this into
the body of this page and that's it so I
just have a big paragraph at the moment
inside of my body let me go back to my
browser let me open up this file called
responsive.html to make the point that
it is not yet responsive let me go ahead
and click on responsive.html that looks
fine but here's another trick you can do
using Chrome or Edge or other browsers
these days you can pretend to be another
device let me go to view developer
developer tools again last time we used
this to use the network tab which was
kind of interesting because we could see
what the underlying Network traffic is
but notice we can also click on this
icon in Chrome at least that looks like
a mobile phone I can turn my laptop into
what looks like a mobile device by
clicking this I'm going to click the dot
dot menu over here and just move the
dock instead of on the bottom where it
might be by default I'm going to move it
to the right hand side so that now on
the left you see what looks more like
the shape of a vertical phone and in
fact if I go to my Dimensions here I'll
choose something like iPhone x so a few
years back here's what that same website
might look like on an iPhone x you know
that looks pretty damn small you know to
be able to read it and that's because
the website has not automatically
responded to The Fairly narrow
dimensions of the iPhone in question or
Android device or whatnot so let me go
ahead and do this let me go back into my
code and let me go into the head of the
page and for the first time add another
tag up here this word is now all over
the internet but there is a meta tag
that is called that allows you to
specify the name of some kind of
configuration detail here or property if
you will viewport is the technical term
for the rectangular region that the
human sees in a browser it's essentially
the body of the page but only the part
the human is currently seeing and you
can specify the content of the viewport
should have an initial scale of one so
it shouldn't be zoomed in or out and the
width that the browser should assume
should be equal to the devices with
these are sort of magical statements
that you just have to know or copy paste
or transcribe that just expressed to the
browser assume that the width of the
page is the same thing as the width of
the device don't assume the luxury of a
big laptop or desktop computer now
making only that change let me go back
to my pretend iPhone here using Chrome's
developer tools let me reload the page
and now it's not very effective on this
screen if I were showing you this on
[Music]
is there well I'm there we go let's do
this there we go so if I zoom into a
hundred percent this would be on an
actual physical device much more
readable than it would have been a
moment ago even though I realized that
demo was not necessarily persuasive but
it's as simple as telling the browser to
resize the thing to the width of the
page all right let me pause here to see
if there's any questions because that
feels like enough HTML tags We'll add
just a couple of more in but for the
most part like HTML tags are things you
Google and figure out over time just to
build up your vocabulary the basic
building blocks are tags attributes some
attributes have values some do not and
that's sort of the structure of HTML in
essence
questions on any of these though yeah
do attributes have an order uh no
attributes can be in any order from left
to right I tend to be a little nitpicky
and so I alphabetize them if only
because then I can easily spot if
something's Missy if it missing if it's
not there alphabetically most people on
the internet don't seem to be uh do that
yeah in the middle
yeah good question I mentioned that HTML
is starting to replace other languages
for user interfaces and it's not just
HTML alone it's HTML with CSS with
JavaScript both of which we'll get a
taste of here today that rather has been
the trend for portability and the
ability for companies for individual
programmers to write one version of an
app and have it work on Android devices
and iPhones and Macs and PCs and the
like it is very expensive it is very
time consuming to learn a language like
Java and write an Android app learn
another language called Swift and make
an IOS app not to mention make them look
and behave the same not to mention fix a
bug in one and then remember to fix it
in the other I mean this is just very
painful and time consuming and costly so
this this standardization on HTML CSS
and JavaScript even for mobile apps and
web apps has been increasingly
compelling because it solves problems
like that
all right so let's go ahead and now do
something that's finally interactive all
of these Pages thus far really just
tastes of static content content that
does not change well let's go ahead and
and do this let me introduce one other
format of URLs which looks a little
something like it did before so slash
path but it could actually be something
like this slash path question mark key
equals value you might not have noticed
or cared to notice the URLs in your url
bar every day but these things are
everywhere often when you type into a
search engine like Google a search query
whatever you just typed ends up in the
URL when you click on a link that
contains some information there might be
a question mark and then some keys and
values there might be an ampersand and
more keys and values here again is that
very common programming Paradigm of just
associating keys with values we can see
this as follows let me actually go to
google.com in a browser here and let me
search for something the internet is
filled with cats enter
notice now that my URL changed from
google.com to google.com search question
mark Q equals cats Ampersand and then a
bunch of stuff that I don't understand
or know so let's just delete it for now
and leave it with the essence of that
URL and that still works if I zoom out
here years ago you would get pictures of
cats now you get videos of the the movie
and the top query there's cat's a bad
movie
um but we can also of course click on
images and they are the adorable creepy
cats all right this didn't used to
happen when we searched for cats but
anyhow the point is that the URL changed
to include the user's input and this is
such a simple but such a powerful thing
this is how humans provide input to
servers they don't manually create the
URLs like I sort of just did but when
you fill out a form on the web and you
hit enter typically the URL suddenly
changes to include whatever you typed in
in the URL assuming the form is you
using the verb get that's not ideal if
you're typing in a username a password a
credit card information because you
don't want the next person to sit down
at your laptop to see literally
everything you typed in saved in your
history so there's another verb post
that can hide all of that and it's just
sent a little differently but things
like this are typically sent via get and
what that means underneath the hood is
that your browser is just making a
request like this get slash search
question mark Q equals whatever you
typed in the host that you visited and
so forth and hopefully what comes back
is a page full of search results
including cats and what's interesting
here now is if I go back to vs code on
my own computer
and let me go ahead and create a file
called how about search.html
in search.html I'm going to start with
some copy paste from before change my
title to search and in the body of this
page I'm going to introduce a form tag
and in this form tag I'm going to have a
couple of inputs and the types of inputs
are going to be text
and the type of the input is going to be
submit
and this isn't that interesting yet but
let's see what's happening in the page
itself let me go back to my directory
listing let me click on search.html I
seem to have the beginning of my own
search engine it's not very interesting
it's just a text box and a submit button
but let's finish my thoughts here so
let's specifically give this text box a
name of Q which if you roll back to the
late 90s when Larry and Sergey of Google
Fame created google.com Q represented
query the query that the human's typing
in so the name of this text box shall be
uh text that shall be Q the form is
going to use what method technically it
uses get by default but I'll be explicit
and say method equals quote unquote get
stupidly it's lowercase in HTML even
though what's in the envelope is indeed
uppercase by convention
the action of this form specifically
would ideally go to my own server but we
don't really have time today to
implement Google itself so we're just
going to send the user's request to
google.com search
so I'm creating a form the action of
which is to send the data to Google's
search path using the get method it's
going to send a input called Q whenever
I click this submit button let me go
back to the browser reload the page
nothing seems to have changed yet but if
I search for let me zoom out so we can
see the URL bar right now I'm in
search.html
if I zoom out and search for cats now
and click submit I'm whisked away to
google.com but notice that the URL is
parameterized with those key value pairs
that key value pair and I get back a
whole bunch of cat results and I can
very easily now make this a little
prettier right now it's not ideal that
like the human has to move their cursor
and click in the box and it's a little
obnoxious that autocomplete is enabled
if I don't want to search for cats
anymore well according to html's
documentation I can say something like
this autocomplete equals off to turn off
autocomplete auto focus to automatically
put the cursor inside of that text box
if I want some explanatory text I can
put placeholder text like quote unquote
query
and now if I go back to this page and
reload now it's a little more user
friendly you see query and kind of gray
text the cursor is already there and
blinking I don't have to even move my
cursor I can search for dogs now and you
didn't see any autocomplete at all hit
enter to submit and now I'm searching
for there we go adorable dogs instead so
what have I done I've implemented the
front end of google.com just not the
back end so implement the back end we're
obviously going to need like a really
big database maybe something like SQL
we're going to need some code that like
searches the database for dogs or cats
or anything else we're going to need
python for something like that and in
fact that's the direction we're steering
next week when we Implement that back
end but today it's all about this front
end or any question then about
forms these URL parameters
before we now transition to making
things look a little prettier with CSS
and then we'll and by making things a
little more functional with JavaScript
anything at all
no all right so let's start to answer a
couple of the questions they came up by
making these Pages a little more
aesthetically interesting let's go ahead
now and introduce to the mix one other
language as follows let me go ahead and
create a file called home.html as though
I'm making a home page for the very
first time and in this page I'm going to
give a title of home I'm just going to
have like three things first I'm going
to have maybe a paragraph
of text up here at the top that says
something welcoming for my home page
like my name John Harvard for instance
for John Harvard's homepage then in the
middle of the page I'm going to have
some text like uh welcome to my home
page exclamation point and at the bottom
of the page I'm going to have a final
paragraph that says something like
copyright the copyright symbol John
Harvard or something like that all right
so it's like a web page with three
different structural areas made with
text this isn't that interesting if I
open this page called home.html let me
go ahead and create three quick
paragraphs a first paragraph for John
Harvard inside the middle I'm going to
say something like welcome to my home
page exclamation point and at the bottom
whoops at the bottom a little footer
that says something like copyright a
little simple copyright symbol and John
Harvard's name all right now let me
reload the page and there we go it's
very simple very underwhelming web page
that has three main sections let's start
to now stylize this in an interesting
way so that it's a little more
aesthetically pleasing first these
aren't really paragraphs they're sort of
like areas of the page divisions like
the header is up here there's like the
main part of my screen and then there's
the footer of my screen so paragraphs
isn't quite right if these aren't really
paragraphs of texts I might more
properly call them dibs or divisions of
the page which is a very commonly used
tag in HTML which just has this generic
rectangular region to it it does not do
anything aesthetically no bold facing no
size changes it just creates an
invisible rectangular region inside of
which you can start to style the text or
I can take this one step further there's
some other tags in HTML known as
semantic tags that literally have names
that describe the types of your page
which is all the more compelling these
days for accessibility to for screen
readers for search engines because now a
screen reader a search engine can
realize that footer is probably a little
fluffy the header might be a little
interesting the main part of the page is
probably the juicy part that I want
users to be able to search for or read
aloud substantively so let's start to
stylize this page somehow let's
introduce a style attribute in HTML
inside of which is going to be text like
this font size colon large text align
Colon Center
on Main I'm going to add a style
attribute and say font size medium text
align Center
and then on the footer I'm going to say
style equals font size small text align
Center
what's going on here well in blue is the
language we promised called CSS for
cascading style sheets we're not really
seeing the cascading style sheet of it
yet but in blue here notice is another
very common Paradigm it's different
syntax now
but how would you describe what you're
looking at here in blue this is another
example of what kind of programming
convention
yeah it's just more key value pairs
right it'd be nice if the world
standardized how you write key value
pairs because we've now seen equal signs
and arrows and colons and semicolons and
all this but it's just different
languages different choices the key here
is font Dash size the value is large the
other key is text Dash align the coal
the value is Center the semicolon just
separates one key value pair from
another just like in the URL the
Ampersand did in the context of HTTP the
designers of CSS use semicolons instead
strictly speaking this semicolon isn't
necessary I tend to include it just for
symmetry but it doesn't matter because
there's nothing after that this is a bit
of a weird example this is the
commingling of CSS inside of JavaScript
so as of now you can use the CSS
language inside of the quote marks in
the value of a style attribute we did
something a little similarly last two
weeks a week plus ago when we included
some SQL inside of python so again
languages can kind of cross barriers
together but we're going to clean this
up because this is going to get messy
quickly certainly for large web pages
the size of harvards or yales or the
like
so let's see what this looks like let me
go back to my browser window here reload
the page
and it's not that different but it's
indeed centered and it's indeed large
medium and small text and let me make
one refinement the copyright symbol
actually can be expressed but there's no
key on my US keyboard here I can
actually magically say uh Ampersand hash
169 semicolon using what's called an
HTML entity turns out there are numeric
codes with this weird syntax that allow
you to specify symbols that exist in
Macs and PCs and phones but that don't
exist on most keyboards if I reload the
page now now it's a proper copyright
symbol so mine are aesthetic but it
introduces us to these HTML entities
so even if you've never seen CSS before
you can probably find something kind of
dumb about what I did here like poor
design it is correct if my goal was
small medium and large bottom up
what looks like a bad design perhaps
even if you've never seen this language
before yeah
yeah I've used the same style three
times like copy paste or typing the
exact same thing again and again it has
rarely been a good thing well here's
where we can take advantage of the
design of CSS because it supports what
we might call inheritance whereby child
children inherit the properties the key
value pairs of their parents or
ancestors and what that means is I can
do this let me get rid of this text
aligned let me get rid of this text of
line let me get rid of this one I could
get rid of the semicolon too but I'll
leave it for now and let me add all of
that style to the parent element the
body so that it sort of Cascades down to
the header the main and the footer tags
as well and let me close my quotes there
too now if I go back to my browser and
hit reload nothing changes but it's a
little better designed right because if
I want to change the text alignment to
maybe be right aligned I can now reload
the page and voila now it's over there I
change it in one place not in three
different places so that would seem to
be marginally better design
and could we do this any more
differently well it's not that elegant
that it's all just kind of in line with
my HTML this generally tends to be bad
practice where you co-mingle your HTML
and your CSS especially since some of
you might be really good at like laying
out the structure of web pages and the
content and the data and you might have
a horrible sense of design or just not
care about the Aesthetics you might work
with a designer an artist who's much
better at all of these fine tunings
aesthetically wouldn't it be nice if you
could work on the HTML they could work
on the CSS and you don't have to somehow
like literally edit the same lines of
code AS each other well just like we can
move stuff into header files in C or
packages in Python we can do the same in
CSS so I'm actually going to go ahead
and do this let me get rid of all of
these style attributes and let me now
start to practice a Convention of not
co-mingling CSS with my HTML let me
instead move it into the head of the
page in a style tag instead of an
attribute this this is one of the rare
examples where they there are attributes
that have the same name Zips tags as
vice versa it's not very common but this
one does exist
here's a slightly different Syntax for
expressing the same key value pairs if I
want to apply CSS properties that is key
value pairs to the header of the page I
say header and then I use curly braces
and inside of those I say font Dash size
large text Dash align Center
then if I want to apply some properties
to the main section of the page I again
do font size say medium and then I can
do text align Center then lastly on the
footer of the page I can assign some
properties like font size small and then
text align Center semicolon and I don't
have to do anything more in my HTML it
all is just represents the structure of
my page but because of this style tag in
the head of the page the browser knows
in advance that the moment it encounters
a header tag a main tag or a footer tag
it should apply those properties those
Styles if I reload the page other than
it being re-centered now there's no
other changes all we're doing is sort of
iteratively improving the design here
but now everything's in the top of the
file but there's still a bad design here
what could I now do that would be
smarter
similar problem to before
yeah
okay create a new file with just the CSS
I like that let's go there in just one
second but even as we're here there's
still a redundancy we can probably chip
away at yeah get rid of the text align
Center in three different places which
doesn't seem necessary and perhaps
someone else if I get rid of text align
Center what should I add to my style tag
in order to bring it back but apply it
to everything in the page and the page
if I scroll down looks like this in HTML
yeah
yeah so the body tag so let me go ahead
and say body and then in here put text
align Center and that now if I reload
the page has no visual effect but it's
just better design because now I
factored out that kind of commonality
and so just to make clear what we've
been doing here these are all again CSS
properties these key value Pairs and
there's different types of ways of using
them and there's this whole taxonomy
what we've been doing thus far or what
we're going to call type selectors where
the type is the name of a tag and so it
turns out there's other ways though to
do this and let's head in this direction
let's go ahead and maybe write our CSS
slightly differently because you know it
would be nice I bet after today once I
start creating other files for my home
page or John Harvard's homepage I might
want to have Center text on other pages
and I might want to have large text or
medium text or small text it'd be nice
if I could reuse these properties again
and again and kind of create my own
Library maybe even ultimately putting it
in a separate file so let me do this
instead of explicitly applying text
align Center to the body let me create a
new noun or an adjective rather for
myself called centered it has to start
with the dot because what I'm doing is
inventing my own class so to speak this
has nothing to do with classes in Java
or python class here is this aesthetic
feature and actually let me rename these
to be dot large dot medium and Dot small
what this is doing for me is it's
inventing new words well named words
that I can now use in this file or
potentially in other web pages I make as
follows I can now say if I want to
Center the whole body I can say class
equals centered on the header tag I can
say class equals large on the main tag I
can say class equals medium on the
footer tag I can say class equals small
but let me take this one step further as
you suggested why don't I go ahead now
and let me actually get rid let me grab
all of the CSS copy it to my clipboard
let me get rid of the style tag here and
create a new file called home.css
and let me just save all of that same
text in a separate file ending in dot
CSS nothing else no HTML whatsoever but
let me go back to my home.html page and
this is one of the most annoyingly named
tags because it doesn't really mean what
it does this link href home.css Rel
equals style sheet so ideally we would
have used the link tag for links and web
pages but this is Link in the sort of
conceptual sense we're linking this file
to this other one so that they work
together
using this hyper-reference home.css the
relationship of that file to this one is
that of style sheet a style sheet is a
file containing a whole bunch of
stylizations a whole bunch of properties
as we just did so here too it's
underwhelming the effect if I reload the
page nothing changed but now I not only
have a better design here because I can
now use those same classes in my second
page that I might make my third page my
fourth page my bio my you know resume
page whatever it is I'm making on my
website here I can reuse those styles by
just including one line of code instead
of copying and pasting all of that style
stuff into file after file after file
and Heck if the rest of the world is
really impressed by my centered class
and my large and medium and small
classes I could bundle this up let other
people on the internet download it and I
have my own Library my own CSS library
that other people can use why should you
ever invent a centered class again if I
already did it for you stupid and small
as this one is but it would be nice now
to package this up in a way that's
usable
by other people as well
so this is perhaps the best design when
it comes to CSS use classes where you
can use external style sheets where you
can but don't use the style attribute
where we began which while explicit
starts to get messy quickly especially
for large files
all right any questions then on this
no all right so that's class selectors
when you specify dot something that
means you're selecting all of the tags
in the page that have that particular
class and applying those properties so
there's a couple of others here just to
give you a taste now of what's possible
there's so much more that you can
actually do with HTML and CSS together
let me go ahead and open up a few
examples that I did here in advance let
me go ahead and open up vs code and let
me go ahead and copy
um my source 8 directory
give me one sec to grab the source 8
directory for today's lectures so that I
can now go into my browser
go into some of the pre-made examples in
Source a and let me open up paragraphs
one here so here's something it's a
little subtle
but does anyone notice how this is
stylized
this is just some generic lorem of some
text again but what's noteworthy
stylistically
a book might do this
yeah
a little bigger why who knows it's just
a stylistic thing at the beginning of
the chapter the first paragraph is
bigger how did we do that well we can
actually explore this in a couple of
ways one I can obviously go into vs code
and show you the code but now that we're
using Chrome and we're using these
developer tools let's again go into them
view developer developer tools and now
notice let me turn off the mobile
feature and let me move the dock back to
the bottom just so that it's fully wide
we looked at the network tab before we
looked at the mobile button before now
let me click on elements what's nice
about the elements tab is you can see a
pretty printed version of the web pages
HTML nicely color coded syntax
highlighted for you so that you can now
henceforth learn from look at the source
code the HTML source code of any web
page on the internet notice that my own
web page here it's not that interesting
there's a bunch of paragraph tags of
alarm ipsum text but notice what I did
the very first one I gave an ID to this
is something that you as a web designer
can do you can give an ID attribute to
any tag in a page to give it a unique
identifier the onus is on you not to
reuse the word anywhere else if you if
you reuse it you've screwed up it's
incorrect Behavior but I chose an ID of
first just so that I have some way of
referring to the very first paragraph in
this file if I look in the head of the
page and the style tag here notice that
I have hash first so just as I use dot
for classes the world of CSS uses a hash
symbol to represent IDs unique IDs and
what this is telling the browser
whatever element has the first ID f i r
s t without the hash apply font size
larger to it and that's why the first
paragraph and only the first paragraph
is actually stylized if I actually go
into vs code now and let me go into my
source 8 directory let me open up
paragraphs1.html
here's the actual file if I want to
change the color of that first paragraph
to Green for instance I can do color
colon green let me close the developer
tools reload the page and now that page
is green as well you don't have to just
use words you can use
[Music]
hexadecimal what was the hex code for
Green in RGB
like no red lots of green no blue so you
could do 0 0 ff00 using a hash which
coincidentally is the same symbol but it
has nothing to do with IDs this is just
how Photoshop and web pages represent
Colors Let's go back here and reload
it's the same although it's slightly
different version of green this is pure
green here if I want to change it to Red
that would be let's see RGB
ff000 and here I can go and reload now
it's first paragraph red this actually
gets pretty tedious quickly like if
you're a web designer trying to make a
website for the first time it actually
might be fun to Tinker with the website
before you open up your editor and you
start making changes and save and reload
that's just more steps so notice what
you can do with developer tools too in
Chrome and other browsers when I
highlight over this paragraph under the
elements tab notice that one it gets
highlighted in blue if I move my cursor
it doesn't get highlighted if I move it
it gets highlighted so it's showing me
what that tag represents but notice over
here on the right right you can also see
all of the stylizations of that
particular element some of them are
built in the italicized ones here at the
bottom means user agent style sheet that
means this is what Google makes all
paragraphs look like by default but in
non-italicized here you see hash first
which is my code that I just changed and
if I want to start tinkering with colors
I can do like zero zero zero zero FF
enter
I changed it to Blue but notice if I go
back to vs code I didn't change my
original vs code code this is now purely
client-side and this is a key detail
when I drew that picture earlier of the
browser going making a request to the
cloud the server and the cloud and the
response coming back the browser your
Mac your PC your phone has a copy of all
the HTML and CSS so you can change it
here however you actually want and for
instance you can do this with any
website let's go uh say on a field trip
here to
uh how about stanford.edu
so here's Stanford's website as of today
uh let's go ahead here and let's see
there's their admissions page campus
life and so forth let me go ahead and
view developer tools on Stanford's page
developer tools elements you can see all
of their HTML and notice it's collapsed
so here is their header
here's their main part and you can I'm
using my keyboard shortcuts to just open
and close the tags to dive in deeper and
deeper suppose you want to kind of mess
with Stanford you can actually like
right click on any element of a page or
control click inspect and that's going
to jump you automatically to the tag in
the elements tab that shows you that
link and notice if I hover over this Li
notice Stanford's using a list as an
unordered list from left to right though
it doesn't have to be a bulleted list
top to bottom they've used CSS to change
it to be a list from news events
academics research Healthcare campus
admission about well so much for
admission that's gone so now if I close
developer tools now it's gone from
Stanford's website but of course what
have I really done
I've just like mutated my own local copy
so this is not hacking even though this
might be how they do it in TV in the
movies it's still there if I reload the
page but it's a wonderfully powerful way
to one just iterate quickly and I try
different things stylistically figure
out how you want to design something and
two just learn how Stanford did
something so for instance if I right
click or control click on admission
again go to inspect and let me go to the
LI tag let me keep going up up up up to
the UL tag there's going to be a lot
going on here but notice they have
applied all of these CSS properties to
that particular UL tag but notice here
this is how it's something like this and
we'd have to read more to learn how this
works list style type none this is how
they probably got rid of the bullets and
what you can do is just Tinker like all
right well what does this do well let me
uncheck it all right didn't really
change anything font weight uncheck this
there we go so now the margin is changed
the padding around it has changed let's
get rid of this we can just start
turning things on and off just to get a
sense of how the web page works I'm not
really learning anything here so far let
me go to the LI here for uh let's go to
the admissions one here
um margin
there we go okay so when you there's a
display property in CSS that's
apparently effectively changing things
from vertical to horizontal if I turn
that off now Stanford's links all look
like this and there are those bullets so
again just default styles that they've
somehow overridden and a good web
designer just knows ultimately how to do
these kinds of things all right how
about a couple final building blocks
before we'll take one more break and
then we'll dive in with JavaScript to
manipulate this stuff programmatically
let me go ahead and open up how about
paragraphs two here let me close this
tab let me go into paragraphs two which
is pre-made and this one looks the same
except when I go ahead and inspect this
first paragraph notice that I was able
to get rid of the ID somehow which is
just to say there's many many ways to
solve problems in HTML and CSS just like
there is in C in Python let me look in
the head and the style of the page now
this is what we might call a this is
another type of selector that allows us
to specify of a paragraph tag that
itself happens to be the first child
only so you can apply CSS to a very
specific child namely first child
there's also Syntax for last child if
just the first one is supposed to look a
little different so here I've just
gotten out of the business of creating
my own unique identifier and instead I'm
using this type of selector as well well
what more can we do let me go into
another example here called
link1.html and here we have a very
simple page that just says visit Harvard
but notice it's purple by default
because we've been to harvard.edu before
let's see if we can't maybe stylize
Harvard's links to be a little different
let me go into linked version 2 now
which looks like this and now Harvard is
very red how did I do that well let me
right click on it click inspect and I
can start to poke around it looks like
my HTML is not at all noteworthy it's
just very simple HTML anchor tag with an
href so let's look at the style let me
zoom out and we can look at it in two
different ways we can literally look at
the style contents here or we can look
at Chrome's pretty version of it over
here it looks like my style sheet in the
style tag has changed the color to be
red and the text decoration which is a
new thing but it's another CSS property
To None notice if I turn that off links
on the internet are underlined by
default which tends to be good for
familiarity for visibility for
accessibility but if it's very obvious
what is text and what is a link maybe
you change text decoration to none but
maybe watch this maybe the link comes
back the line comes back when you hover
over it well let's look at how I did
this in style notice that I have
stylization and I put my curly braces on
the same line here as tends to be
convention in CSS color is red text
decoration is none but whenever an
anchor tag is hovered over
you can change the decoration text
decoration to be back to the default
underline so again just little ways of
playing around with the Aesthetics of
the page once you understand that really
there's just different types of
selectors and you might have to remind
yourself look them up occasionally as to
what the syntax is but it's just another
way of scoping your properties to
specific tags let's look at a version
three of this here which adds Yale to
the mix if I go to link3.html maybe I
want to have Harvard links read
Yale links blue how might I have done
this well let's right click and click
inspect
and here we might have two lengths with
a couple of techniques just to again
emphasize you can do this so many
different ways I gave my Harvard link an
ID of Harvard my Yale link an ID of Yale
in my CSS if we go to the head of the
page I then did this
the tag with the Harvard ID AKA hash
Harvard should be read hash Yale should
be blue and then any anchor tag should
have no text decoration unless you hover
over it at which point it should be
underlined and so if I hover over
Harvard it's red underlined Yale it's
blue underlined if I want to get rid of
the IDS I can do this a slightly
different way let me go into link four
same effect but notice I got rid of the
IDS now how else can I express myself
well let's look at the CSS here the
anchor tag has no text decoration by
default unless you're hovering over it
and this is kind of cool this is what we
would call on our list here an attribute
selector where you spec select tags
using CSS notation based on an attribute
so this is saying go ahead and find any
anchor tag whose href value happens to
equal this URL and make it red do the
same for Yale and make it blue now this
might not be ideal because if there's
something after the slash these equal
signs don't work because if it's a
different Harvard or different Yale link
this is a little too precise so let me
look at version 5 here of link.html look
at this style and I did this a little
smarter this is new syntax and again
just the kind of thing you look up star
equals means change any anchor tag whose
href contains anywhere in it harvard.edu
to red and do the same thing for Yale
based on Star equals so star here
connotes wild card so search for
harvard.edu or yale.edu anywhere in the
href and if it's there colorize the link
and again we could do this all day long
with diminishing returns to actually
achieve the same kind of stylizations in
different ways and as projects just get
larger and larger you just have more and
more decisions to make and so you have
certain conventions you start to adopt
and indeed if I may you have the
introduction of what are called
Frameworks ultimately if you're a
full-time web developer or you're
working for a company doing the same you
might have internal conventions that you
adhere to for instance the company might
say always use classes don't use IDs or
always use attribute selectors or don't
use this and it wouldn't be necessarily
as draconia as that Draconian is that
but they might have a style guide of
sorts but what many people and many
companies do nowadays is they do not
come up with all of their own CSS
properties they start with something off
the shelf a framework typically a free
and open source framework that just
gives them a lot of pretty stylizations
for free just by using a third-party
library and one of the most popular ones
nowadays is something called bootstrap
that cs50 uses on all of its websites
super popular in Industry as well it's
at
getbootstrap.com and this is just to
give you a taste of it a website that
documents the library that they offer
and there's so much documentation here
but let me just go to things like how
about components it just gives you out
of the box the CSS with which you can
create little alerts if you've ever
noticed on cs50's website little
colorful warnings that the top of the
page or call outs to draw your attention
to things how did we do that it's
probably a paragraph tag or a div tag
and maybe we change the font color we
change the background color right it's a
lot of stuff we could absolutely do from
scratch but you know what why do I
reinvent the wheel if we can just use
bootstrap so for instance let me just
scroll down if you've ever seen on
cs50's website a yellow warning alert
like this let me just zoom in
on this we are just using HTML like this
we're using a div tag which again is an
invisible division a rectangular region
of the page but we're using classes
called alert and another class called
Alert warning those are classes that the
friend the the folks at bootstrap
invented they Associated certain text
colors and background colors and padding
and margin and like other Aesthetics
with so all we have to do is use those
classes role equals alert just makes
clear to like a screen reader that this
is an alert that should probably be
recited and whatever's in between the
open tag and close tag is what the human
would see how do you use something like
bootstrap well you just read the
documentation under getting started
there is a link tag you copy paste into
your own so let me do this so in
table.html we had code like this let me
actually read bootstraps documentation
really fast and they tell me dot dot
copy paste this code I'm going to put
this into the head of my page and it's
quite long but notice it's a link tag
which I used earlier for my own CSS file
the href of which is this CDN link
content delivery Network that's
referring to a specific version of
bootstrap that's available on this day
and the file that I'm including is
called
bootstrap.min.css this is an actual file
I can visit with my browser if I open
this in a separate tab this is the CSS
that bootstrap has made freely available
to us crazy long no white space that's
because it's been minimized just to not
waste Space by adding lots of white
space and comments but this contains a
whole lot hundreds of CSS properties
that we can reuse thanks to classes that
they invented if I want to use some
JavaScript code I can also copy this
script tag but we'll come back to that
before long let me now just make a
couple of tweaks to this this table if I
go into my browser from before this is
what it looked like previously where
name and number were bold but centered
and then Carter and David were on the
left and the numbers were to the right
you know it's fine it's not that pretty
but it'd be nice if it were a little
prettier than that so if we add
bootstrap into it notice one thing
happens first when I reload the page
no longer are Chrome's default styles
used Now bootstraps default styles are
used which is a way of enforcing
similarity across Chrome Edge Firefox
Safari and others notice it went from a
serif font to a Sans serif fonts and
something cleaner like this it still
looks pretty ugly but let me go into
bootstraps documentation
let me go under their uh content tab for
tables and if I just kind of start
skimming this these are some good
looking tables right like there's some
underlining here some uh it's Bolder
font there's a dark line if I keep going
oh that's getting pretty too if I want
to have a colorful table like I could
figure all of this stuff out myself if I
want sort of dark mode here uh if I want
to have uh alternating highlights and so
forth there's so many different
stylizations of tables that I could do
myself but I care about making a phone
book not about Reinventing these wheels
so if I read the documentation closely
it turns out that all I need to do is
add bootstraps table class to my table
tag and watch with a simple reload what
my now table.html file looks like much
nicer right might not be what you want
but my god with like two lines of code I
just really prettied things up and so
here then is the value of using
something like a framework it allows you
to actually create much prettier Much
More Much More user-friendly websites
than you might otherwise be able to make
on your own certainly quickly in fact
let's iterate one more time on one other
example before we introduce a bit of
that code let me go ahead and open up uh
search.html from before which recall
looked like this and search.html in my
browser
was this very simple Google search and
suppose I want to reinvent google.com's
UI a bit more here's a screenshot of
google.com on a typical day it's got an
about link a store link Gmail images
these weird dots sign in their logo it's
not appearing well on the screen here
but there's a big text box in the middle
and then two buttons Google search and
I'm feeling lucky well could I maybe go
about implementing this UI myself using
some HTML some CSS and maybe bootstraps
help just so I don't have to figure out
all of these various stylizations well
here's my starting point in search.html
let's go and add in bootstrap first and
foremost so that we have access to all
of their classes that are reusable now
and let me go ahead and
figure out how to do this well just like
Stanford's site had like its nav
navigation bar using a UL but they
changed it from being a bulleted list to
being left to right I bet I can do
something like this myself so let me go
into the body of my page and first based
on bootstraps documentation let me add a
div called a div with a class of
container fluid container fluid is just
a class that comes with bootstrap that
says make your web page fluid that is
grow to fill the window so that way it's
going to resize nicely I'm going to go
ahead and fix my indentation here if you
haven't discovered this yet if you
highlight multiple lines in vs code you
can hit Tab and indent them all at once
so now I have all of that inside of this
div now just like in Stanford's site
let's create an unordered list
that has maybe An Li uh called uh with a
class of nav item
and then in here whoops in here let me
go ahead and say
uh a
href equals https colon slash about dot
Google which is the real URL of Google's
about page and I'll put the about text
in there then I'm going to close my li
tag here and I want to do one other
thing because I'm using bootstrap
bootstraps documentation if I read it
closely says to add a class to your
links called like nav link and text dark
to make it dark like black or dark gray
instead of the default blue all right so
I think I have now an about Link in a
navigation part of my screen let me go
ahead and save this and reload
all right so not exactly what I wanted
it's a bulleted list still so I need to
override this somehow let me read
bootstraps documentation a little more
clearly and let me pretend to do that
for time's sake if I go under content
oops if I go under components and I go
to navs and tabs long story short if you
want to create a pretty menu like this
where your links are from the left to
the right just like Stanford I
essentially need HTML like this and this
is subtle but I left off this class I
should have added a class called nav on
my UL so that was my bed let me go in
here and say add class equals nav and
then again this class nav item bootstrap
told me to nav link text dark bootstrap
told me to let me go back to my page
here reload and okay it's still kind of
ugly but at least the about link is in
the top left hand corner just like it
should be in the real google.com now let
me whip up a couple of more links real
fast let me go and do a little copy
paste so I bet next week we can avoid
this kind of copy paste let me change
this link to uh be store.google.com the
text will be store
let me go ahead and create another one
here for Gmail
so this one's going to go to officially
how about technically it's
www.google.com Gmail
normally it just redirects and let me
grab one more of these and for Google
images and I'm going to paste this
whoops I'm gonna come on I'm going to
put this here too this is going to be
images and that URL is IMG HP is the URL
all right let me go ahead and reload the
browser page now it's coming along right
about storage email images it's not
quite what I want so I'd have to read
the documentation to figure out how to
maybe nudge one of these over to start
right aligning it and there's a couple
of ways to do this but one way is if I
want Gmail to move all the way over and
push everything else I can say that
at uh add some margin
to the Gmail list item margin start Auto
this is in bootstraps documentation a
way of saying whatever space you have
just automatically shove everything
apart and now if I reload the page again
now voila Gmail and images is over to
the right all right so now we're kind of
moving along let me go ahead and add the
big blue button to sign in so here with
sign in let me go ahead and over in my
same nav yeah so let's go ahead and do
one more Li class equals nav item and
then inside of this Li tag what am I
going to do turns out there is a class
that can turn a link into a button if
you say BTN for button and then button
primary makes it blue the href for this
one is going to be https
accounts.google.com service login which
is literally where you go if you click
on the big blue button the role of this
link is that of button and then sign in
is going to be the text on it if I now
reload the page now we're getting even
closer although it looks a little stupid
notice that sign in is way in the top
right hand corner whereas the real
google.com has a little bit of margin
around it okay that's an easy fix too
let me go back into my HTML here let me
add margin Dash three this two is a
bootstrap thing they have a class called
M Dash something the something is a
number from like one to five I believe
that adds just some amount of white
white space so if I reload now now okay
it's just a little prettier and now let
me accelerate just to demonstrate how I
can take this home let me go ahead and
open up my pre-made version of this
whereby
I added to this
some final flourishes if I go to
search2.html I decided to replace their
logo with just this out of a cat and
notice that I re-implemented essentially
google.com here's a text box here's two
buttons even though they're a little
washed out on the screen I even figured
out how to get dots that look pretty
similar to Google's and if we view
Source you can see how I kind of finish
this code if I go to view developer
tools and I go to elements
and I go into this div and I go into
this div you'll see that here's an image
tag for happy cat and I added some
classes there to make it fluid and width
25 of the screen if I go into the form
tag this is the same form tag as before
but notice I used button tags this time
with button and button light classes and
then I stylize them in a certain way and
so in the end result if I want to go
ahead and search now for birds and click
Google search voila I've implemented
something that's pretty darn close to
google.com without even touching raw CSS
myself and now here's the value then of
a framework you can just start to use
off-the-shelf functionality that someone
else created for you but if you want to
make refinements you don't really like
the shade of blue that bootstrap chose
or the gray button or you want to curve
things a bit more that's where you can
create your own CSS file and do the last
mile sort of fine tuning things and that
tends to be best practice stand on the
shoulders of others as much as you can
using libraries and then if you really
don't like what the library is doing
then use your own skills and
understanding of HTML and CSS to refine
things
a bit further
but still after all of that all of these
examples we've done thus far are still
static other than the Google one which
searches on the real google.com let's
take a final five minute break and we'll
give you a sense of what we can next do
next week onward with JavaScript see you
in five
all right so I think it's fair to say
we're about to see our very last
language next week and final projects
are ultimately going to be about
synthesizing so many of these thankfully
this language called JavaScript is quite
similar syntactically to both C and
Python and indeed if you can imagine
doing something in either of those you
can probably do it in some form in
JavaScript the most fundamental
difference today though is that when you
have written C code and python code thus
far you've done it on the server you've
done it in the terminal window
environment and when you run the code
it's running in the cloud on the server
the difference now today with JavaScript
is even though you're going to write it
in the cloud using vs code recall that
when a browser gets the page containing
this code it's going to get a copy of
the HTML the CSS and the JavaScript code
so JavaScript that we see today is all
going to be executed in the browser on
user's own Max PCS and phones not in the
server JavaScript can be used on the
server using an environment called
node.js it's an alternate to python or
Ruby or Java or other languages we are
using it today client side which is a
key difference so in scratch let's do
this one last time if you wanted to
create a variable in scratch setting
counter equal to zero in JavaScript it's
going to look like this you don't
specify the type but you do use the
keyword let and there's a few others as
well that say let counter equals zero
semicolon if you want to increment that
variable by one you and JavaScript could
say something like counter equals
counter plus one or you can do it more
succinctly with plus equals or the plus
plus is back in JavaScript you can now
say counter plus plus semicolon again in
scratch if you wanted to do a
conditional like this asking if x less
than y it looks pretty much like C the
parentheses are unfortunately back the
curly braces here are back if you have
multiple statements in particular but
syntactically it's pretty much the same
as it was for if for if else and even
for its else if else unlike python it's
two words again again else if so quite
quite like C nothing new beyond that if
you want to do something forever in
scratch you'd use this block in
JavaScript you can do it a few ways
similar to python similar to C you'd say
while true in JavaScript booleans are
lowercase again just like in C so it's
lowercase true if you want to do
something a finite number of times like
repeat three times looks almost like C
as well the only difference really is
using the word let here instead of ins
and again you'll use let to create a
string or an inch or any other type of
variable in JavaScript the browser will
figure out what type you mean from
Context in C we would have said int
instead
ultimately this language and that's it
for our tour of JavaScript syntax
there's Bunches of other features but
syntactically it's going to be that
accessible relatively speaking the power
of JavaScript running in the user's
browser is going to be that you can
change this thing in memory think about
most any website that's at all
interesting today that you use it's
typically very interactive and dynamic
if you're sitting in front of Gmail on a
laptop or desktop with the browser tab
open and someone sends you an email all
of a sudden another row appears in your
inbox another row another row how is
that implemented honestly it could be an
HTML table maybe it's a bunch of dibs
top to bottom the point though is you
don't have to hit command r or control R
to reload the page to see more email it
automatically appears every few seconds
or minutes how is that working when you
visit gmail.com You are downloading not
just HTML and CSS with your initial
inbox presumably you're downloading some
JavaScript code that is designed to keep
talking every second every 10 seconds or
something to Gmail servers and they then
are using their code to add another
element another element another element
to the existing Dom document object
model which is the fancy term for tree
in memory that represents HTML so that
the web page can continue to update in
real time Google Maps same thing if you
click and drag and drag and drag your
browser did not download the entire
world to your Mac or PC by default it
only the downloaded what's in your
viewport the rectangular region but when
you click and drag it's going to get
some more tiles up there some more
images some more images as you keep
dragging using JavaScript again behind
the scenes so let's actually use
JavaScript to start interacting with
Pages how can we do this we can put the
JavaScript code in the head of the page
in the body of the page or even Factor
it out to a separate file so let's take
a look here is a new version of
hello.html that during the break I just
added a form to because it'd be nice if
this page didn't just say hello title
hello body it said hello David hello
Carter hello whoever uses it I've got a
form that I borrowed from some of our
earlier code and that form has an input
whose ID is name and whose uh that also
has a submit button but there's no code
in this yet so let's add a little bit of
JavaScript code as follows suppose that
when this form is submitted I want to
greet the user how can I do that well
let's do it the somewhat messy way first
I can add an attribute called on submit
to the form element and I can say on
submit call a function called greet
close quotes unfortunately this function
doesn't yet exist but I can make it
exist but there's another detail here
when the user clicks submit normally
forms get submitted to the server I
don't want to do that today I want to
just submit the form to the browsers
keep on the same page and just print on
the screen hello David or so forth so
I'm also going to go ahead and say
return false and this is a JavaScript
way of telling the browser even when the
user tries to submit the form return
false like no don't let them actually
submit the form but do call this
function called greet in the head of my
page I'm going to add a script tag where
in the language is implicitly JavaScript
and has no relationship for those of you
who took apcs with Java just a similarly
named language but no relation I am
going to name a function called greet
apparently in JavaScript the way you
create a function is you literally say
the word function instead of Def you
don't specify a return but type and in
this function I could do something like
this
alert quote unquote uh how about hello
there initially I'm going to keep it
simple using a built-in function called
alert which is not a good user interface
there are better ways to do this but
we're doing something simple first let
me now go ahead and load this page again
it still looks as simple as before with
just a simple text box I'll zoom in to
make it bigger I'm going to type my name
but I think it's going to be ignored
when I click submit it just says hello
there and this is again this is an ugly
user interface it literally says the
whole code space URL of the web page is
saying this to you it's really just
meant for simple interactions like this
for now all right let's have it say
hello David somehow well how can I do
this well if this element on the page
was given by me a unique ID it'd be nice
if just like in CSS I can go grab the
value of that text box using code and I
actually can let me go ahead and do this
let me store in a variable called name
the result of calling a special function
called document.com query selector
this query selector function is
javascript's version of what we were
doing in CSS to select nodes using
hashes or dots or other syntax it's the
same syntax so if I want to select the
element whose unique ID is name I can
literally just pass in single or double
quotes hash name just like in CSS that
gives me the actual node from the tree
it gives me one of these rectangles from
the Dom the document object model if I
actually want to get at the specific
value they're in I need to go one step
further and say dot value so similar in
spirit to python where we saw a lot of
dot notation where you can go inside an
object inside of an object that's what's
going on long story short in JavaScript
there is a special Global variable
called document that lets you just do
stuff with the document the web page
itself one of those functions is called
query selector that function returns to
you whatever it is you're selecting and
Dot value means go inside of that
rectangle and grab the actual text that
the human typed in so so if I want to
now say hello to that person the syntax
is a little different from C and python
I can use concatenation which actually
does exist in Python but we didn't use
it much I can go ahead and say hello
quote unquote uh hello plus name all
right now if I go back to the browser
window reload the page to get the latest
version of the code Type in David and
click submit now I see hello David not
the best website but it does demonstrate
how I can start to interact with the
page but let me stipulate that this
commingling of languages is never a good
thing it's fine to use classes but using
style equals quote unquote and a whole
bunch of CSS that was not going to scale
well once you have lots and lots of
properties same here once you have more
and more code you don't want to just put
your code inside of this on submit
Handler so there's a better way let's
get rid of that on submit attribute and
literally never use it again that was
for demonstration's sake only and let's
do this let me move the script tag
actually just below the form but still
inside the body so that the script tag
exists only after the form tag exists
logically just like in Python your code
is read top to bottom left to right and
let me now do this let me Define this
function called grit and then let me do
this document dot query selector let me
select the form on the page it doesn't
have a unique ID it doesn't need to I
can just reference it by name form
because there's only one of them and let
me call this special function add event
listener this is a function that listens
for events now this is actually a term
of art within programming many different
languages are governed by events and
pretty much any user interface is
governed by events especially phones on
phones you have touches and you have
drags and you have long press and you
have pinch and all of these other
gestures on your Mac or PC you have
click you have drag you have key down
key up as you're moving your hands up
and down on the keyboard This is a a
non-exhaustive list of all of the events
that you can listen for in the context
of web programming and this might be a
throwback to scratch where recall
scratch let you broadcast events and we
had the two puppets sort of talking to
one another via events in the world of
web programming game programming any
human physical device these days they're
just governed by events and you write
code that listens for these events
happening so what do I want to listen
for well I want to add an event listener
for the submit event and when that
happens I want to call the Greet
function like this
so this is kind of interesting
thank you I have my greet function as
before no changes but I'm adding one
line of code down here I'm telling the
browser to use document.queryselector to
select the form then I'm adding an event
listener specifically for the submit
event and when that happens I call greet
notice I'm not using parentheses after
greet I don't want to call greet right
away I want to tell the browser to call
greet when it hears this submit event
now let me go ahead and
um
let me go ahead and
deliberately I think trip over something
here let me type in my name David submit
and there we go all right hello David
all right but let's let's now make this
slightly better designed right now I'm
defining a function greet which is fine
but I'm only using it in one place and
you might recall we we stumbled on this
in Python where I was like why are we
creating a special function called get
value when we're only using it like one
line later and we introduced what type
of function in Python the other day
yeah so Lambda functions Anonymous
functions you can actually do this in
JavaScript as well if I want to define a
function all at once I can actually do
this let me cut this onto my clipboard
paste it over here let me fix all of the
alignment let me get rid of the name and
I can actually now
do this the syntax is a little weird but
using now just these four lines of code
I can do this I can tell the browser to
add an event listener for the submit
event and then when it hears that call
this function that has no name and
unlike python this function can have
multiple lines which is actually a nice
thing it looks a little weird there's a
lot of indentation curly braces going on
now but you can think of this as just
being run these two lines of code when
the form is submitted but if I want to
block the form from actually being
submitted I got to do one other thing
and you would only know this from being
told it or reading the documentation I
need to do this function prevent default
passing in this e argument which is a
variable that represents the event more
on that another time that just allows us
to prevent whatever the default handling
of that particular event is so long
story short this is representative of
the type of code you might write in
JavaScript whereby you can actually
interact with your code the user's
actual form and we can do interesting
things 2 built into browsers nowadays
this functionality like this so here's a
very simple example that has just three
buttons in it one red one green one blue
well it turns out using JavaScript you
can control the CSS of a page
programmatically I can change the
background of the body of the page to
Red to green to blue just by listening
for clicks on these buttons and then
changing CSS properties just to give you
a taste of this if I view the page as
Source similar code here I can select
the red button by an ID that I
apparently defined on it right up here I
can add an event listener this time not
for submit but for click and when it's
clicked I execute this one line of code
and this one line of code we haven't
seen before but you can go into the body
of the page it's style property and you
can change its background color to Red
this is one example of like two
different groups not talking to one
another in advance in CSS properties
that have two words are usually
hyphenated like background Dash color
unfortunately in JavaScript if you do
something Dash something that's
subtraction which is logically
nonsensical here so in CSS you can
convert background Dash color to in
JavaScript background color where you
capitalize the C and you get rid of the
minus sign what else can we do here well
back in the day there used to be a blink
tag and it's one of the few historical
examples of a tag that was removed from
HTML because in the late 90s early 2000s
this is what the web looked like there's
a lot of this kind of stuff there was
even a marquee that would move text from
left to one right over the screen and
the web was a very ugly place I will
admit my very first web page probably
used both of these tags but how can we
bring it back well this is a version of
the blink tag implemented in JavaScript
how I wrote some code in this example
that Waits every 500 milliseconds to
change the CSS of the page to be visible
invisible visible invisible because
built into JavaScript is support for a
clock so you can just do something on
some sort of schedule let me go ahead
and open up this example Auto completes
let me Zoom back out in
autocomplete.html I whipped up as an
example that has just a text box but I
also grabbed the dictionary from problem
set five speller so that if I want to
search for something like apple this
searches that 140 000 words using
JavaScript to create what we know in the
world of the web as autocomplete when
you start searching for something you
sure start to see words that start with
that phrase and sure enough if I search
for something like banana here's the
three variants of bananas that appear in
that file and so forth how is that
working just JavaScript when it finds
matching words it's just updating the
Dom the tree and the computer's memory
to show more and more text or less and
for one final example this is how
programs like doordash and Google Maps
and ubereats and so work you have built
into browsers today some fancy apis
application programming interfaces
whereby you can ask for information
about the user's device for instance
here I wrote a program in
geolocation.html that's apparently
asking to know my location
all right let me go ahead and allow it
this time if that's something you're
comfortable with on your own device
it's taking a moment because sometimes
these things take a little while to
analyze but hopefully in just a moment
there are apparently my GPS coordinates
and as a final flourish today for what
you can do with a little bit of HTML for
your structure CSS for your style and
now JavaScript for your logic which will
tie in again next week let me go ahead
and search Google for those GPS
coordinates zoom in here
on Google Maps and if we zoom in in okay
we're pretty close we're not on that
street but there oh there it is actually
there's the marker it had put for us
we're indeed here in Memorial Hall so
all that with JavaScript the basic
understanding of the Dom and the
document object model we'll pick up
where we left off next week and now add
a back end see you next time
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50 and this is week nine and
this is kind of it in terms of
programming fundamentals today we come
rather full circle with so many of the
languages that we've been looking at
over the past several weeks and with
HTML and CSS and JavaScript last week
we're going to add back into the mix
Python and SQL and with that do we have
the ability to program for the web and
even though this isn't the only user
interface out there increasingly are
people certainly using laptops and
desktops and a browser to access
applications that people have written
but it's also increasingly the way that
mobile apps are written as well there
are languages called Swift for iOS there
are languages called Java for Android
but coding applications in both of those
language means knowing twice as many
language building twice as many
applications potentially so we're
increasingly seeing For Better or For
Worse that the world is starting to
really standardize at least for the next
some number of years on HTML CSS and
JavaScript coupled with other languages
like Python and SQL on the so-called
back end and so today we'll tie all of
those together and give you the last of
the tools in your toolkit with which to
tackle final projects to go off into the
real world ultimately and somehow solve
problems with programming but we need an
additional tool today and we've sort of
outgrown HTTP server this is just a
program that comes on certain computers
that you can install for free happens to
be written in a language called
JavaScript but it's a program that we've
been using to run a web server in vs
code but you can run it on your own Mac
or PC or anywhere else but all this
particular HTTP server does is serve up
static content like HTML files CSS files
JavaScript files maybe images Maybe
video files but just static content it
has no ability to really interact with
the user Beyond Simple clicks you can
create a web form and serve it visually
using HTTP server but if the human types
in input into a form and click submit
unless you submit it elsewhere to
something like google.com like we did
last time it's not actually going to go
go anywhere because this server can't
actually process the requests that are
coming in so today we're going to
introduce another type of server that
comes with python that allows us to not
only serve web pages but also process
user input and recall that all that
input is going to come ultimately from
the URL or more deeply inside of those
virtual envelopes so here's like the
canonical URL we talked about last week
for random website like
www.example.com and I've highlighted the
slash just to connote the the root of
the web server like the default folder
where presumably there's a file called
index.html or something else in there
otherwise you might have a more explicit
mention of the actual file name
file.html you can have folders as you
probably gleaned from the most recent
problem set you can have files in
folders like this and these are all
examples of what a programmer would
typically call a path so it might not
just be a single word it might have
multiple slashes and multiple folders
and sold folders and files but this is
just more generally known as a path but
there's another term of art that's
essentially equivalent that wants you
today this is also synonymously called a
route which is maybe a better generic
description of what these things are
because it turns out they don't have to
map to that is referred to a specific
folder or a specific file you can come
up with your own routes in a website and
just make sure that when the user visits
that you give them a certain web page if
they visit something else you give them
a different web page it doesn't have to
map to a very specific file as we'll
soon see and if you want to get input
from the user just like Google does like
Q equals cats you can add a question
mark at the end of this route the key or
the HTTP parameter name that you want to
Define for yourself and then equal some
value that presumably the human typed in
if you have more of these you can put an
ampersand and then more key equals value
pairs Ampersand repeat repeat repeat
the catch though is that using what the
tools that we had last week alone we
don't really have the ability to parse
that is to analyze and extract things
like Q equals cats you could have
appended question and Mark Q equals cats
or anything else to any of your URLs in
your home page for problem set 8 but it
doesn't actually do anything useful
necessarily unless you use some fancy
JavaScript the server is not going to
bother even looking at that for you but
today we're going to introduce using a
bit of python and in fact we're going to
use a web server implemented in Python
instead of using HTTP server alone to
automatically for you look for any key
value pairs after the question mark and
then hand them to you in the form of a
python dictionary recall that a
dictionary in Python a dict object is
just key value pairs that seems like a
perfect fit for these kinds of
parameters and you're not going to have
to write that code yourself it's going
to be handed to you by way of what's
called a framework so this will be the
second of two Frameworks really that we
look at in the class and a framework is
essentially a bunch of libraries that
someone else wrote and a set of
conventions therefore for doing things
so those of you who really started
dabbling with bootstrap this past week
to make your home pages prettier and
nicely laid out you were using a
framework why well you're using
libraries code that someone else wrote
like all the CSS maybe some of the
JavaScript that the bootstrap people
wrote for you but it's also a framework
in the sense that you kind of have to go
all in like you have to use bootstraps
classes and you have to kind of lay out
your divs or your spans or your table
tags in a sort of bootstrap friendly way
and it's now too onerous but you're
following conventions that a bunch of
humans standardized on so similarly in
the world of python is there another
framework we're going to start using
today and whereas bootstrap is used for
CSS and JavaScript flask is going to be
used for Python and it just solves a lot
of common problems for us it's going to
make it easier for us to analyze the
URLs and get at key value pairs it's
going to make it easier for us to find
files or images that the human wants to
see when visiting our website it's even
going to make it easier to send emails
automatically like when someone fills
out a form you can dynamically using
Code send them an email as well so flask
and with it some related did libraries
it's just going to make stuff like that
easier for us and to do this all we have
to do is adhere to some pretty
minimalist requirements of this
framework we're going to have to create
a file for ourselves called app.pi This
is where our web app or application is
going to live if we have any libraries
that we want to use the convention in
the python world is to have a very
simple text file called requirements.txt
where you list the names of those
libraries top to bottom in that text
file similar in spirit to the include or
the import statements that we saw in C
in Python respectively we're going to
have a static folder or static directory
which means any files you create that
are not ever going to change like images
CSS files JavaScript files they're going
to go in this folder and then lastly any
HTML that you write web pages you want
the human to see are going to go in a
folder called templates so this is again
evidence of what we mean by a framework
like do you have to make a web app like
this no but if you're using this
particular framework this is what people
decided would be the human conventions
if you've heard of other Frameworks like
Django or asp.net or Bunches of others
there are just different conventions out
there for creating applications flask is
a very nice micro framework and that
that's it like all you have to do is
kind of adhere to these pretty
minimalist requirements to get some code
up and running
all right
so let's go ahead and make a web app let
me go ahead and switch over to vs code
here and let me practice what I'm
preaching here by first creating app dot
pi and let's go ahead and create a
application that very simply maybe says
hello to the user so something that
initially is not all that Dynamic pretty
static in fact but we'll build on that
as we've always done so in app.pi what
I'm going to do first is exactly the
line of code I had on the screen earlier
from flask import flask with a capital f
second and a lowercase f first and I'm
also going to preemptively import a
couple of functions render template and
request more on those in just a bit and
then below that I'm going to say go
ahead and do this give me a web a
variable called app that's going to be
the result of calling the flask function
and passing in it this weird incantation
here name so we've seen this a few weeks
back when we played around with python
and we had that if main thing at the
bottom of the screen for now just know
that underscore underscore name
underscore underscore refers to the name
of the current file and so this line
here simple as it is tells python hey
python turn this file into a flask
application flask is a function that
just figures out then how to do the rest
the last thing I'm going to do for this
very simple web application is this I'm
going to say that I'm going to have a
function called index that takes no
arguments and whenever this function is
called I want to return the results of
rendering a template called
index.html and that's it so let's assume
there's a file somewhere haven't created
it yet called index.html but render
template means render this file that is
printed to the user's screen so to speak
the last thing I'm going to do is I have
to tell flask when to call this index
function and so I'm going to tell it to
define a route for quote-unquote Slash
and that's it so let's take a look at
what I just created here this is
slightly new syntax and it's really the
only weirdness that we'll have today in
Python this is what's known in Python is
what's called a decorator a decorator is
a special type of function that modifies
essentially another function for our
purposes just know that on line six this
says Hey python Define a route for Slash
the default page on my web application
the next two lines seven and eight say
hey python Define a function called
index takes no arguments and the only
thing you should ever do is return
render template of quote unquote
index.html
all right so that's it so really the
next question naturally should be like
all right well what is in uh
index.html well let me go ahead and do
that next let me create a directory
called templates practicing again what I
preached earlier so I'm going to create
a new empty directory called templates
I'm going to go and uh CD into that
directory and then do code of index.html
so here's going to be my index page and
I'm going to do a very simple web page
doctype HTML just going to borrow some
stuff from last week HTML language
equals English I'll close that tag I'll
then do a head tag I'll do a meta tag
the name of which is viewport this makes
my site recall responsive that is it
just grows and shrink to fit the size of
the device the initial scale for which
is going to be one and the width of
which is going to be device with so I'm
typing this out I have it printed here
this is stuff I typically copy paste but
then lastly I'm going to add in my title
which will just be hello for the name of
this app and then the body whoops and
Bobby the body of this tag will be
there we go the body of this page rather
will just be hello comma world so very
uninteresting and really kind of a
regression to where we began last week
but let's go now and experiment with
these two files I'm not going to bother
with a static folder right now because I
don't have any other files that I want
to serve up no images no CSS nothing
like that and honestly requirements.txt
is going to be pretty simple I'm going
to go requirements.txt and just say make
sure the system has access to the flask
Library itself all right but that's the
only thing I'm going to add in there for
now all right so now I have two files
app.pi and I have index.html but
index.html thank you is inside of my
templates directory so how do I actually
start a web server last week I would
have said HTTP server but HTTP server is
not a python thing it has no idea about
flask or python or anything I just wrote
HTTP server will just spit out static
files so if I ran HTTP server and then I
clicked on app.pi I would literally see
my python code it would not get X
executed because HTTP server is just for
static content but today I'm going to
run a different command called flask run
so this framework flask that I actually
pre-installed in advance that's so it
wasn't strictly necessary that I create
that requirements.txt file just yet
comes with a program called flask takes
command line arguments like the word run
and when I do that you'll see somewhat
similar output to last week whereby
you'll see the name your URL for your
unique preview of that you might see a
pop-up saying that your application is
running on TCP Port something or other
by default last week we used port 8080
flask just because prefers Port 5000 so
that's fine too I'm going to go ahead
and open up this URL now
and once it authenticates and redirects
me just to make sure I'm allowed to
access that particular Port let me zoom
in voila there's the extent of this
application if I view Source by
right-clicking or control clicking
there's my HTML that's been spit out so
really I've just reinvented the Wheel
from last week because there's no
dynamism now nothing at all but what if
I do this let me close the source and
let me zoom out so you can see my URL
bar let me zoom in now and I have a very
unique cryptic URL but the point is that
it ends with nothing or implicitly it
ends with Slash this is just Chrome
being a little helpful it doesn't bother
showing you a slash even though it's
implicitly there but let me do something
explicit like
my name equals quote unquote David so
there's a key value pair that I've
manually typed into my URL bar and hit
enter
okay nothing happens nothing changes it
still says hello world but the
opportunity today is to now dynamically
get at the input from that URL and start
displaying it to the user so let me go
back over here to my terminal window and
code let me move that down to the bottom
there and what if I want to say huh
hello name I ideally want to say
something like I don't want to hard code
David because then it's never going to
say any hello to anyone else I kind of
want to put like a variable name here
like name should go here but it's not an
HTML tag so I need some kind of
placeholder well here's what I can do if
I go back to my python code I can now
Define a variable called name and I can
ask flask to go into the current request
into its argument that is in the URL as
they're called and get whatever the
value of the parameter called name is
that puts that into a variable for me
and then in render template this is one
of those functions that can take more
than one argument if it takes another
argument you can pass in the name of any
variable you want so if I want to pass
in my name I can literally say name
equals name so this is the name of a
variable I want to give to the template
this is the actual variable that I want
to get the value from and now lastly in
my index.html the syntax as of today in
flask is to do two curly braces and then
put the name of the variable that you
want to plug in
so here's what we mean by a template a
template is kind of like a blueprint in
the real world where it's like planned
to make something this is the plan to
make a web page that has all of this
code literally but there's this
placeholder with two curly braces here
and here that says go ahead and plug in
the value of the name variable right
there so in this sense it's similar in
spirit to our F strings or format
strings in Python the syntax is a little
different just because reasonable people
disagree different people different
Frameworks come up with different
conventions the convention in flask in
their templates is to use two curly
braces here the hope is that you the
programmer will never want to display
two curly braces in your actual web page
but even if you do there's a work around
we can escape that so now let me go
ahead and go back to my browser tab here
previously even though I added name
equals David to the end of the URL with
a question mark it still said hello
world but now hopefully if I made these
changes let me go ahead and open up my
terminal window I'm let me restart flask
so it loads my changes by default let me
go back to my hello Tab and click reload
so it grabs the page Anew from the
server
and there we go hello David I can play
around now and I can change the url up
here to for instance Carter zoom out hit
enter and now we have something more
Dynamic so the new pieces here are in
Python we have some code here that
allows us to access programmatically
everything that's after the question
mark in the URL and the only thing we
have to do to do that is call this
function
request.orgs.get you and I don't have to
bother figuring out where's the question
mark where is the equal sign where are
the ampersands potentially the framework
flask does all of that for us
okay any questions then on these
principles thus far
yeah and back
[Music]
why do you need a question mark in the
URL
the short answer is uh just because that
is where key value pairs must go if
you're making a get request from a
browser to a server the convention
standardized by the HTTP protocol is to
put them in the URL after the so-called
route or path than a question mark and
it delineates what's part of the route
or the path and what's part of the human
input to the right
other questions yeah
sure this is this annoying thing about
python when you pass in parameters two
functions that have names you typically
say something equals something else so
let me make a slight tweak here uh how
about I say name of person here this
allows me to invent my own
variable for my template and assign it
the value of name I now though have to
go into my index file and say name of
person did I get that right name of
person yeah so these two have to match
and so this is just kind of stupid
because it's unnecessarily verbose so
what typically people do is they just
use the same name as the variable itself
even though it looks admittedly kind of
stupid but it has two different roles
the thing to the left of the equal sign
is the name of the variable you plan to
use in the template the thing on the
right is the actual value you're
assigning it and this is because it's
general purpose I could override this
and I could say something like name
always equals Emma no matter what that
variable is and now if I go back to my
browser and reload no matter what's in
the URL David or Carter it's always okay
Emma broke the server uh
what did I do oh I might I didn't change
my template back there we go let me
change that back to be name so that its
name there and its name here but I've
hard-coded Emma's name so now we're only
ever going to see Emma no matter whose
name is in the URL that's all
right so this is kind of bad user
interface if in order to get a greeting
for the day you the user have to
manually change the url which none of us
ever do this is not like how web pages
work how what is the more normal
mechanism for getting input from the
user and putting it in that URL
automatically
how did we do that last week
with Google if you recall
[Music]
okay so we did make something in order
to get the input from the user and
specifically what was the the tag or the
terminology we used last week
sorry a little letter
oh no
but yeah
so the input tag inside of the form tag
so in short forms are of course like how
the web works and how we typically get
input from the user whether it's a
button or a text box or a drop down menu
or something else so let's go ahead and
add that into the mix here so let's
enhance this Hello app to do a little
something more by this time just doing
this let me get rid of this name stuff
and let me just have a very simple
index.html file but that by default is
going to Simply ask the user for some
input as follows I'm going to go back
into my
index.html and instead of printing out
the user's name this is the page I'm
going to use to actually get input from
the user so I'm going to create a form
tag the method I'm going to use for now
is going to be quote unquote get then
inside of that form I'm going to have an
input tag and I'm going to turn off
autocomplete like we did last week I'm
going to turn on auto focus so it puts
the cursor in the text box for me I'm
going to give the name of this input the
name name not to be too confusing but
I'm asking the human for their name so
it makes sense sense that the name of
the input should be quote unquote name
the placeholder I want the human to see
in light gray text will be named with a
capital N just so it's a little
grammatical and then type of this text
field type of this input is going to be
text then I'm just going to give myself
like last week a submit button and I
don't care what it says it's just going
to say the default submit terminology
let me go ahead now and open up my
terminal window again let me go to that
same URL
so that I can see whoops
there we go so that was just cast from
earlier let me go back to that same URL
my GitHub review.dev URL and here I have
the form and now I can type in anything
I want the catch though is when I click
submit where is it going to go well
let's be explicit it does have a default
value but let me go into my index.html
and let me add just like we did last
week for Google whereas previously I
said something like
www.google.com search but today we're
not going to rely on some third party
I'm going to implement the so-called
back end and I'm going to have the user
submit this form to a second route not
just slash but how about Slash greet I
can make it up whatever I want greet
feels like a nice operative word so
slash greet is where the user will be
sent when they click submit on this form
alright so let's go ahead now and go
back to my browser tab let me go ahead
actually and let me reload flask here so
that it reloads all of my changes let me
reload this tab so that I get the very
latest HTML and indeed quick safety
check if I view page page Source we
indeed see that my browser has
downloaded the latest HTML so it
definitely has changed let's go ahead
and type in David and when I click
submit here
what's going to happen
hypotheses
what's going to happen visually
functionally however you want to
interpret when I click submit
yeah
okay the user is going to go to an empty
page pretty good Instinct because
nowhere else have I mentioned slash
greet doesn't seem to exist how's the
URL going to change just to be clear
what's going to appear suddenly in the
URL
yeah
404 no not in the URL specifically in
the URL something's going to get added
automatically when I click
the key value pair right that's how
forms work that's why our Google trick
last week worked I sort of recreated a
form on my own website and even though I
didn't get around to implementing
google.com itself I can still send the
information to Google Just relying on
browsers standardizing to your question
earlier that whenever you submit a form
it automatically ends up after a
question mark in the URL if you're using
get so this both of you are right this
is going to break and all three of you
are right in effect 404 not found you
can see it in the tab here that's the
error that has come back but what's
interesting and most important the URL
did change and it went to slash greet
question mark name equals David so I
just now need to add some logic that
actually looks for that so-called route
so let me go back to my app.pi let me
Define another route for quote unquote
slash greet and then inside of under
this let me Define another function I'll
call it uh greet but I could call it
anything I want no arguments for now for
this and then let me go ahead and do
this in my app.pi this time around I do
want to get the human's name so let me
say
request.orgs get quote unquote name and
let me store that in a variable called
name then let me return a template and
you know what I'm going to give myself a
new template greet.html because this has
a different purpose it's not a form I
want to say hello to the user in this
HTML file and I want to pass into it the
name that the human just typed in
all right so now if I go up and reload
the page what might happen now
other logical check here
if I go ahead and hit reload or resubmit
the form what might happen now
any instincts
let me try so let's try this let's go
ahead and reload the page previously it
was not found now it's worse and this is
the 500 error internal server error that
I promise next week we will all
encounter accidentally ultimately but
here we have an internal server error
because it's an internal error this
means something's wrong with your code
so the route was actually found because
it's not a 404 this time but if we go
into vs code here and we look at the
console the terminal window you'll see
that this is actually a bit misleading
uh do I want to do this let me reload
this
let me reload here oh standby
come on
there we go
okay here we have this error here and
this is where your terminal window is
going to be helpful in your terminal
window by default is typically going to
go helpful stuff like a log log of what
it is the server is seeing from the
browser for instance here's what the
server just saw in purple get slash
Greek question mark name equals David
using HTTP version 5 1.0 here though is
the status code that the server returned
500 why what's the error well here's
where we get these annoying pretty
cryptic python messages that help 50
might ultimately help you with or here
we might just have a clue at the bottom
and this is actually pretty clear even
though we've never seen this error
before what did I screw up here I just
didn't create greet.html right template
not found all right so that must be the
last piece of the puzzle and again
representative of how you might diagnose
problems like these let me go into my
terminal window after hitting Ctrl C
which cancels or interrupts a process
let me go into my templates directory if
I type LS I own only have index.html so
let's code up greet.html and in this
file let's quickly do doctype
doctype HTML Open Bracket HTML language
equals English inside of this I'll have
the head tag inside of here I'll have
the meta the name is viewport the
content of which is uh see I always
forget this too
the content of which is initial scale
equals one with equals device with quote
unquote title is still going to be I'll
call this Greek because this is my
template and then here in the body I'm
going to have hello comma name so I
could have kept the around to the old
version of this but I just recreated
essentially my second template so
index.html now is almost the same but
the title is different and it has a form
greet.html is almost the same but it
does not have a form it just has the
hello comma name so let me now go ahead
and rerun in the correct directory you
have to run flask wherever app.pi is not
in your templates directory so let me do
flask run to get back to where I was
let me go into my other tab cross my
fingers this time that when I go back to
slash and I get index.html's form now I
type in David and click submit now
we get hello David and now we have kind
of a full-fledged web app that has two
different routes slash and slash greet
the latter of which takes input like
this and then using a template spits it
out but something could go wrong let's
see what happens here suppose I don't
type anything in let me go here and just
click submit now
I mean it looks kind of stupid so
there's Bunches of ways we could solve
this I could require that the user have
input on the previous page I could have
some kind of error check for this but
there's another mechanism I can use that
I'll just show you it turns out this get
function in the context of HTTP and also
in general with python dictionaries you
can actually Supply a default value so
if there is no name parameter or no
value for a name parameter you can
actually give it a default value like
this so I'll say world for instance now
let me go back here let me type in
nothing again and click submit and
hopefully this time I'll in oops sorry
let me restart flask to reload the
template let me go ahead and type
nothing this time clicking submit and
hopefully
we now oh
interesting I should have faked this uh
suppose that
the reason this uh suppose I just get
rid of name altogether like this and hit
enter now I see Hello World and this is
a subtlety that I didn't intend to get
into here when you have question mark
name equals nothing you're passing in
what's called whoops when you have greet
question mark name equals something you
actually are giving a value to name it
is quote unquote with nothing in between
that is different from having no value
at all so allow me to just propose that
the error here uh we would want to
require this in a different way and
probably the most robust way to do this
would be to go in here in my HTML and
say that the name field is required
now if I go back to my form
after restarting flask here
and I go ahead and click reload on my
form and type in nothing and click
submit now the browser is going to yell
at me but just as a teaser for something
we'll be doing in the next problem set
in terms of error checking you should
never ever ever rely on client-side
safety checks like this because we know
from last week that a curious programmer
can go to inspect and let me poke around
the HTML here let me go into the body
the form okay you save required I say
not required you can just delete what's
in the Dom in the browser and now I can
go ahead and submit this form and it
appears to be broken not a big deal with
a silly little greeting application like
this but if you're trying to require
that humans actually provide input that
is necessary for the correct operation
of the site you don't want to trust that
the HTML is not altered by some
adversary
all right any questions then on this
particular app before we add another
feature here
any questions here
yeah
sorry little ladder in the index
function
sorry
would it be a problem if what
[Music]
no I mean no this is okay what you
should really do is something we're
going to do with another example where
I'm going to start error checking things
so let me wave my hands at that and
propose that we'll solve this better in
just a bit but it's not bad to do what I
just did here it's only going to handle
one of the scenarios that I was worried
about not all of them all right so even
though this is new to most of us here
consider index.html my first template
and consider greet.html my second
template
what might be arguably badly designed
even though this might be the first time
you've ever touched web programming like
this
like what's kind of bad or dumb about
this design of these two templates alone
and there's a reason too that I kind of
bored Us by typing it out that second
time yeah
Chicago
[Music]
yeah there's so much repetition I mean
it was to kind of deliberately tedious
that I was retyping everything the
doctype the HTML tag the head tag the
title tag and little things did change
along the way like the title and
certainly the content of the body but so
much of this I mean almost all of the
page is a copy of itself in multiple
files and God forbid we have a third
template a fourth template a hundredth
template for a really big website this
is going to get very tedious very
quickly and suppose you want to change
something in one place you're gonna have
to change it now in two three a hundred
different places instead so just like in
programming more generally we have this
ability to factor out commonalities so
do you in the context of web programming
and specifically templating have the
ability to factor out all of those
commonalities the syntax is going to be
a little curious but it functionally is
pretty straightforward let me go ahead
and do this let me go ahead and copy the
contents of index.html let me go into my
templates directory and go to file that
by default is called layout Dot HTML and
let me go ahead and per your answer copy
all of those commonalities into this
file now instead so here I have a file
called layout.html I don't want to give
every page the same title maybe but for
now that's okay I'm going to call
everything hello but in the body of the
page what I'm going to do here is just
have a placeholder for actual contents
that do change so in this layout I'm
going to go ahead and here
and just put in the body of my page how
about this syntax and this is admittedly
new block body
and then percent sign close curly brace
and then I'm going to do end block so
kind of a curious syntax here but this
is more template syntax the other
template syntax we saw before was the
two curly braces that's for just
plugging in values there's this other
syntax with flask that allows you to say
a single curly brace a percent sign and
then some functionality like this
defining a block and this one's a little
weird because there's like literally
nothing between the clothes curly and
the open curly brace here but let's see
what this can do for us let me now go
into my
index.html which is where I kind of
borrowed most of that code from and let
me focus on what is minimally different
the only thing that's really different
in this page title aside is the form
so let me go ahead and just cut that
form out to my clipboard let me change
the first line of index.html to say this
this file is going to extend layout.html
and notice I'm using the curly braces
again and this file is going to have its
own body block inside of which is just
the HTML that I actually want to make
specific to this page and I'll keep my
indentation nice and neat here and let's
consider what I've done this is starting
to look weird fast and this is now a mix
of HTML with templating code
index.html first line now says Hey flask
this file extends layout.html whatever
that is this next line 3 through 10 says
Hey flask here is what I consider my
body block to be plug this into the
layout placeholder therefore so if I now
go back to layout.html
in layout.html it's almost all HTML by
contrast but there is this placeholder
and if I want to put a default value I
could say whoops if I want to put a
default value I could put a default
value there just in case some page does
not have a body block but in general
that's not going to be relevant so this
is just a placeholder albeit a little
verbose that says plug in the page
specific content right here
so if I go now into greet.html this
one's even easier I'm going to cut this
content and get rid of everything else
greet.html2 is going to extend
layout.html extends plural and then I'm
going to have my body block here simply
be this one line of code and then I'm
going to go ahead and end that block
here these are not HTML tags this is not
HTML to syntax technically the syntax we
keep seeing with the curly braces and
these now curly braces with percent
signs is an example of Ginger syntax
j-i-n-j-a which is a language that some
humans invented for this purpose of
templating and the people who invented
flask decided we're not going to come up
with our own syntax we're going to use
these other people's syntax called
ginger syntax so again there starts to
be at this point in the tours and really
in Computing a lot of sharing now of
ideas and sharing of code so flask is
using this syntax but other libraries
and other languages might also too all
right so now index.html you know is half
HTML half templating code Ginger syntax
greet.html is almost all Ginger syntax
no tags even but because they both
extend layout.html now I think I've kind
of improved the design of this thing if
I go back to app.pi none of this really
needs to change I don't change my
templates Dimension layout.html that's
already implicit in the fact that we
have the extends keyword so now if I go
ahead and open my terminal window go
back to the same folder as app.pi and do
flask run
all right my application is running on
Port 5000 let me now go back to the
slash route in my browser and hit enter
I have this form again and just as a
little check let me view the source of
the page that my browser is seeing and
there's all of the code no no mention of
Jinja no curly braces no percent signs
just HTML it's not quite pretty printed
in the same way but that's fine because
now we're starting to dynamically
generate websites and by that I mean
this isn't quite indented nicely or
perfectly that's fine if it's indented
in the source code version doesn't
matter what the browser really sees let
me now go ahead and type in my name
click submit I should see yep hello
David let me go ahead and view the
source of this page and we'll see almost
the same thing with what's plugged in
there so this is now web programming in
the literal sense I did not hard code a
page that says hello comma David hello
comma Carter hello comma Emma I hard
coded a page that has a template with a
placeholder and now I'm using actual
logic some code in app.pi to act
actually tell the server what to send
to the browser
are any questions then
on where we're at here this is now a web
application simple though it is it's no
longer just a web site
is it better for design or for memory uh
both it's definitely better for design
because truly if we had a third page
fourth page I would really start just
resorting to copy paste and as you saw
with home page often in the head of your
page you might want to include some CSS
files like bootstrap or something else
you might want to have other information
up there if you had to upgrade the
version of bootstrap or you change
libraries you want to change one of
those lines you would literally have to
go into like three four a hundred
different files to make one simple
change so that's bad design and in terms
of memory yes theoretically the server
because it knows there's this common
layout it can theoretically do some
optimizations underneath the hood flask
is probably doing that but not in the
mode we're using it we're using it in
development mode which means it's
typically reloading things each time
other questions
on this application
anything at all all right so let me ask
a question not just in terms of uh the
code design what about the implications
for privacy like why is this maybe not
the best design for users how I've
implemented this I've used a web form
but yeah
yeah I mean if you have a nosy sibling
or roommate and they have access to your
laptop and they just go trolling through
your autocomplete or your history like
literally what you typed into a website
is going to be visible not a big deal if
it's your name but if it's your password
your credit card or anything else that's
mildly sensitive you probably don't want
it ending up in the URL at all even if
you're in incognito mode or whatnot like
you just don't want to expose yourself
or your users to that kind of risk so
perhaps we can do better than that
unfortunately this one's actually an
easy change let me go into my
index.html where my form is and in my
form I can just change the method from
get to post it's still going to send key
value pairs to the server but it's not
going to put them in the URL the upside
of which is that we can assuage this
privacy concern but I'm going to have to
make one other change too because now if
I go ahead and run flask again after
making that change and I now reload the
form to make sure I have the latest
version you should be in the habit of
going to view developer view Source or
developer tools just to make sure that
what you're seeing in your browser is
what you intend and yes I do see what I
wanted method equals post now let me go
ahead and type in David and click submit
now I get a different error this one is
HTTP 405 method not allowed well why is
that well in my flask application I've
only defined a couple of routes so far
one of which is for slash then that
worked fine one of which is for slash
greet and that used to work fine but
apparently what flask is doing is it
only supports
get by default so if I want to change
this route to support different methods
I can say quote unquote uh post inside
of this parameter here so that now I can
actually support post not just get and
if I now re start flask so flask run
enter
and I go back to this URL let me go back
one screen to the form reload the page
just to make sure I have the latest even
though nothing there has changed type
David and click submit now now I should
see Hello World notice that I'm at the
slash greet route but there's no mention
of
name equals anything in the URL
all right so that's kind of an
interesting takeaway right like it's a
simple change but whereas get puts
things in the URL post does not but it
still works so long as you tweak the
back end to look
as a post request which kind of means
look deeper in the envelope it's not
going to be as simple as looking at the
URL itself why shouldn't we just always
use post
[Music]
like why not use post everywhere
any thoughts right because it's kind of
obnoxious to be putting any information
in URLs if you're leaving these little
breadcrumbs in your history and people
can poke around and see what you've been
doing
[Music]
yeah what do you think
yeah I mean if you get rid of get
requests and put nothing in the URL your
history like your autocomplete gets
pretty less useful right because none of
the information is therefore stored so
you can't just go through the menu and
hit enter you'd have to like refill out
the form and there's this other symptom
that you can see here let me zoom out
and let me just reload this page notice
that you'll get this warning and it'll
look different in Safari and Firefox and
Edge and chrome here confirm form
submission so your browser might
remember what your inputs were and
that's great but just while you're on
the page and this is in contrast to get
where the state state is information
like key value pairs is in embedded in
the URL itself and if you looked at an
email I sent earlier today I
deliberately linked to https colon slash
www.google.com search question mark Q
equals what plus time plus is plus it
this is by definition a get request when
you click on it because it's going to
grab the information that a key value
pair from the URL send it to Google
server and it's just going to work and
the reason I sent this via email earlier
was I wanted people to very quickly be
able to check what is the current time
and so I can sort of automate the
process of creating a Google search for
you but that you induce when you click
that link if Google did not support get
they only supported this the best I
could do is send you all to this URL
which unfortunately has no useful
information I would have had to add to
my email by the way type in the words
what time is it so it's just bad for
usability so there too we might have
design when it comes to the low level
code but also the design when it comes
to the user experience or ux as a
computer scientist would call it just in
terms of what you want to optimize for
ultimately so get and post both have
their roles it depends on what kind of
functionality you want to provide and
what kind of sensitivity there might be
around it
all right any questions then on this our
first web application super simple just
get someone's name and prints it back
out but we kind of now have all the
plumbing with which to create
really most anything we want
no all right let's go ahead and take a
five minute break and when we come back
we'll add to this some first year
intramural sports all right so we are
back and recall that the last thing we
just changed was the route to use post
instead of get So Gone is my name and
any value in the URL but there was kind
of a subtle bug or change here that we
didn't call out earlier like I did type
David into the form and I did click
submit and you hear it is saying hello
comma world
so that seems to be broken all of a
sudden even though we added support for
post
but something must be wrong logically it
must be the case here intuitively that
if I'm seeing hello world that's the
default value I gave the name variable
it must be that it's not seeing a key
called name in request.orgs
which is this gives you access to
everything after the URL that's because
there's this other thing we should know
about which is not just request.orgs but
request.form these are horribly named
but request.orgs is for get requests
request.form is for post requests
otherwise they're pretty much
functionally the same but the onus is on
you the user or the programmer to make
sure you're using the right ones so I
think if we want to get rid of the world
and actually see what I the human typed
in I think I can just change request.org
to request dot form
still dot get still quote unquote name
and now if I go ahead and rerun flask
and my terminal window go back to my
browser go back to and actually I won't
even go back to the form I will
literally just reload command r or
control R and what this war warning is
saying is it's going to submit the same
information to the website when I click
continue now I should see hello comma
David so again you too are going to
encounter probably all these kinds of
like little subtleties but if you focus
on really the first principles of last
week like what is HTTP how does a get
request work how does a post request
work now you should have a lot of the
mental building blocks with which to
solve problems like these and let me
give you one other mental model now for
what it is we're doing this framework
called flask is just an example of many
different Frameworks that all implement
the same Paradigm the same way of
thinking and the same way of programming
applications and that's known as MVC
model view controller and here's a very
simple diagram that represents the
process that you and I have been
implementing thus far and actually it's
this is more than we've been
implementing thus far in app.pi is what
a programmer would typically call the
controller that's the code you're
writing the so-called business logic
that makes all of the decisions decides
what to render what values to show and
so forth in layout.html index.html
greek.html is the so-called view
templates that is the visualizations
that the human actually sees the user
interface those things are kind of dumb
they pretty much just say plop some
values here all of the hard work is done
in app.pi so controller AKA app.pi is
doing is where your python code
generally is and in your view is where
your HTML and your Jinja code your
Ginger templating the curly braces the
curly braces with percent signs usually
is we haven't added an m to MVC yet
model that's going to refer to things
like CSV files or databases the model
where do you keep actual data typically
long term so we'll come back to that
this picture where you have one of these
each of these components kind of inter
communicating with one another is
representative of how a lot of
Frameworks work what we're teaching
today this week is not really specific
to python it's not really specific to
flask even though we're using flask it
really is a very common Paradigm that
you could Implement in Java C sharp or
Bunches of other languages as well all
right so let's now pivot back to uh vs
code here let me stop running flask and
let me go ahead and create a new folder
altogether
after closing these files here
and let me go ahead and create a folder
called frosh IMS representing freshman
intramural sports or first year
intramural sports that I can now CD into
and now I'm going to code an app.pi
and in anticipation I'm going to create
another templates directory this one in
the frosh IMs folder and then in my
templates directory I'm going to create
a layout.html and I'm just going to get
myself started here frosh IMS will go
here I'm just copying my layout from
earlier because most of my interesting
work this time is now going to be
initially in app.pi so what is it we're
creating so like literally the very
first thing I wrote as a web application
like 20 years ago was a site that
literally looked like this so I was like
a sophomore or Junior at the time I
taken cs50 in a follow-on class only I
had no idea how to do web programming
neither of those two courses taught web
programming back in the day so I taught
myself at the time a language called
Pearl and I learned a little something
about CSV files and I sort of read
enough can't even say Googled enough
because Google didn't come out for a
couple of years later read enough online
to figure out how to make a web
application so that students on campus
First Years could actually register via
a website for intramural sports back in
my day you would literally fill out a
piece of paper and then walk it across
the yard to Wigglesworth Hall one of the
dorms slide it under the dorm of the
Proctor or ra and thus you were
registered for sports so 1996 1997 like
we could do better by then there was an
internet just wasn't really being used
much on campus or more generally so uh
background images that repeat infinitely
was kind of in Vogue apparently at the
time all of this was like images that I
had a handmade because we did not have
the features that JavaScript and CSS
nowadays have so it was really just HTML
and it was really just controller code
written not in Python but in Pearl and
it was really just the same building
blocks that we hear already today now
have so we'll get rid of all of the
imagery and focus more on the
functionality in the Aesthetics but
let's see if we can't whip up a web
application via which someone could
register for one such intramural sport
so in app.pi let me go ahead and import
some familiar things now from flask
let's import capital flask which is that
function we need to kick everything kick
start everything render templates so we
have the ability to render that is print
out those templates and request so that
we have the ability to get at input from
the human let me go ahead and create the
application itself using this magical
incantation here and then let's go ahead
and Define a route
for slash for instance first I'm going
to define a function called index but
just to be clear this function could be
anything Foo bar baz anything else but I
tend to name them in a manner that's
consistent with what the route is called
but you could call it anything you want
it's just the function that will get
called for this particular route let me
go ahead here and just get things
started return render template of
index.html just keep it simple nothing
more so there's nothing really frosh I
am specific about this here I just want
to make sure I'm doing everything
correctly meanwhile I've got my layout
okay let me go ahead and in my templates
directory code a file called index.html
and let's just do extends layout dot
HTML at the top just so that we get
benefit from that template and down here
I'm just going to say to do just so that
I have something going on visually to
make sure I've not screwed up yet in my
frosh IMS directory let me do flask run
let me now go back to my previous URL
which used to be my hello example but
now I'm serving up the frosh IM site
oh and I'm seeing nothing that's because
I screwed up accidentally
what did I do wrong in index.html
[Music]
what am I doing wrong this file extends
layout.html but
[Music]
yeah I forgot to tell flask what to plug
into that layout so I just need to say
block body and then in here I can just
say to do or whatever I want to
eventually get around to then end the
block let me end this tag here okay so
now it looks kind of ugly more cryptic
but this is again the essence of doing
templating let me now restart flask up
here let me go back to the page let me
reload crossing my fingers this time and
there we go to do so it's not the
application I want but at least I know I
have some of the plumbing there by
default all right so if I want the user
to be able to register for one of these
Sports let's enhance now index.html to
actually have a form that's maybe got
like a drop down menu for all of the
sports for which you can register so let
me go into this template here and
instead of to do let's go ahead and give
myself
um how about an H1 tag that just says
register so the user knows what it is
they're looking at how about a form tag
that's going to use post just because
it's not really necessary to put this
kind of information in the URL the app
action for that how about we plan to
create a register route so that we're
sending information from slash to a
register route so we'll have to come
back to that in here let me go ahead and
create
um how about in input with autocomplete
equals off auto focus on uh how about a
name equals name because I'm going to
ask the student for their name using
placeholder text of quote unquote name
and the type of this box will be text so
this is pretty much identical to before
but if you've not seen this yet let's
create a select menu a so-called drop
down menu in HTML and maybe the first
option I want to be in there is going to
be oh how about the current three sports
with the for the fall which are uh
basketball
and another option is going to be soccer
and the third options going to be
Ultimate Frisbee for first year
intramural is right now so I've got
those three options I've got my form I
haven't implemented my route yet but
this feels like a good chance a good
chance a good time to go back now and
check if my form has reloaded so let me
go ahead and stop and start flask you'll
see there's ways to automate the process
of restarting the server that we'll do
for you for problem set nine so you
don't have to keep stopping flask let me
reload my index route and okay it's not
that pretty it's not not though maybe
nor was this but it now has at least
some functionality where I can type in
my name and then type in the sport now I
might be biasing people toward
basketball like uxy's user experience
Wise It's kind of obnoxious to like
pre-check basketball but not the others
so there's some little tweaks we can
make there let me go back into
index.html let me create like an empty
option up here that technically
this option is not going to have the
name of any sport but it's just going to
have a word I want the human to see so
I'm actually going to disable this
option and make it selected by default
but I'm going to say sport up here and
there's different ways to do this this
is just one way of creating essentially
a whoops option yep that looks right
creating a placeholder sport so that the
user sees something in the drop down let
me go ahead and restart flask reload the
page and now it's just going to be
marginally better now you see sport
that's checked by default but you have
to check one of these other ones
ultimately all right so that's pretty
good so let me now type in David I'll
register for Ultimate Frisbee okay I
definitely forgot something
submit button so let's add that all
right so input type equals submit all
right let's put that in restart flask
reload okay getting better submit could
be a little prettier recall that we can
change some of these HTTP these HTML
attributes the value of this button
should be register maybe just to make
things a little prettier let me now
reload the page
and register all right so now we really
have the beginnings of the user
interface that I created some years ago
to let people actually register for the
sport so let's go now and create maybe
the other route that we might need let
me go into app.pi and in here if we want
to allow the user to register let's do a
little bit of error checking which I
promised we'd come back to like what
could the user do wrong because assume
that they will one they might not type
their name two they might not choose the
sports so they might just submit an
empty form so that's two things we could
check for just so that we're not storing
like bogus entries in our database
ultimately so let's create another route
called greet slash greet and then in
this route let's create a function
called grit but can be called anything
we want and then let's go ahead and in
the Greet function let's go ahead and
validate the submission so a little
comment to myself here how about if
it there is not a request dot form get
name value
so that is if that function returns
nothing like quote unquote or the
special word none in python or
request.form
dot get quote unquote sport
uh not in quote unquote what were they
basketball
uh the other one was soccer and the last
was Ultimate
frisbee getting a little long but notice
what I'm the question I'm asking if the
user did not give us a name that is if
this function Returns the equivalent of
false which is quote unquote or
literally none if there's no such
parameter or if the sport the user
provided is not some value in basketball
soccer or Ultimate Frisbee which I've
defined as a python list then let's go
ahead and just yell at the user in some
way let's return uh render template of
failure.html and that's just going to be
some error message inside of that file
otherwise if they get this far let's go
ahead and confirm registration by just
returning whoops returning render
template quote unquote success.html
all right so a couple quick things to do
let me first go in and in my templates
directory let's create this
failure.html file and this is just meant
to be a message to the user that they
fail to provide the information
correctly so let me go ahead and in
failure.html not repeat my past mistake
so let me extend layout.html and in the
block body you are not registered I'll
just yell at them like that so that they
know something went wrong and then let
me create one other file called
success.html that similarly is mostly
just Ginger syntax and I'm just going to
say for now even though they're not
technically registered in any database
you are registered that's what we mean
by success
all right so let me go ahead and back in
my frosh IMS directory run flask run
let me go back to the form and reload
should look the same
all right so now let me not cooperate
and just immediately click register and
patiently
okay what did I do wrong register oh I'm
confusing our two examples
all right I spotted the error what did I
do wrong
unintentional
there's where I am what did I actually
invent over here
[Music]
where did I screw up
anyone
thank you so register not greed I had
last example on my mind so the route
should be register ironically the
function could be great because that
actually doesn't matter but to keep
ourselves saying let's use the one in
the same words there let me go ahead now
and start flask as intended let me
reload the form just to make sure all is
working now let me not cooperate and be
a bad user clicking register
[Music]
okay
other unintended mistake but this one
we've seen before notice that by default
routes only support get so if I want to
specifically support post I have to pass
in Via a methods parameter a list of
allowed
route methods that could be get comma
post but if I don't have no need forget
in this context I can just do post all
right now let's do this one last time
reload the form make sure everything's
okay click register and you are not
registered so it's catching that all
right let me go ahead and at least give
them my name register you are not
registered all right fine I'm going to
go ahead and be David with Ultimate
Frisbee register
huh
okay
what should I what did I mean to do here
all right so let's figure this out how
to debug something like this which is my
third and final unintended unforced
error
how can we go about troubleshooting this
turn this into the teachable moment
all right well first some like safety
checks like what did I actually submit
let me go ahead and view page Source A
good rule of thumb look at the HTML that
you actually sent to the user so here I
have an input with a name name so that's
what I intended that looks okay ah I see
it already even though you if you've
never used a select menu might not know
what apparently is missing from here
that I did have for my
text input
just intuitively
like logically what's going through my
head embarrassingly is like all right if
my form thinks that it's missing a name
or a sport how did I create a situation
in which name is blank or sport is blank
well name I don't think is going to be
blank because I explicitly gave this
text field a name name and that did work
last time I've now given a second input
in the form of the select menu but what
seems to be missing here that I'm
assuming exists
here
it's just a dumb mistake I made
[Music]
what might be missing here
if request.form gives you all of the
inputs that the user might have typed in
let me go into my actual code here in my
form and
name equals sport I just didn't give a
name to that input so it exists and the
browser doesn't care it's still going to
display the form to you it just hasn't
given it a unique name to actually
transmit to the server so now if I'm not
going to put my foot in my mouth I think
that's what I did wrong and again my
process for figuring that out was
looking at my code thinking through
logically is this right is this right no
I was missing the name there so let's
run flask
let's reload the form just to make sure
it's all defaults again type in my name
and type in Ultimate Frisbee crossing my
fingers extra hard this time
and there you are registered so I can't
emphasize I did not intend to screw up
in that way but that's exactly the right
kind of thought process to diagnose
issues like this go back to the basics
go back to what HTTP and what HTML forms
are all about and just rule things in
and out there's only a finite number of
ways I could have screwed that up yeah
[Music]
it's gonna say a little louder
why did name equals sport address the
problem well let's first go back to the
HTML previously it was just the reality
that I had this user input drop down
menu but I never gave it a name but
names or more generally key value pairs
is how information is sent from a form
to the server so if there's no name
there's no key to send even if the human
types of value like it would be like
nothing equals Ultimate Frisbee and that
just doesn't work the browser is just
not going to send it however in app.pi I
was naively assuming that in my requests
form there would be a name called
quote-unquote sport it could have been
anything but I was assuming it was sport
but I never told the form that and if I
really wanted to dig in we could do a
little something more let me go back to
the way it was a moment ago let me get
rid of the name of the sport drop down
menu let me rerun flask down here and
reload the form itself after it finishes
being served and now let me do this view
developer tools
and then let me watch the network tab
which recall we played around with a
little bit last week and we also played
around with curl which let us see the
HTTP requests here's another here's what
I would have done if I still wasn't
seeing the error and was really
embarrassed on stage I would have typed
in my name as before I would have chosen
Ultimate Frisbee I would have clicked
register and now I would have looked at
the HTTP request and I would click on
register here and just like we did last
week I would go down to the request down
here and there's a whole lot of stuff
that we can typically ignore but here
let me zoom in way at the bottom what
Chrome's developer tools are doing for
me it's showing me all of the form data
that was submitted so this really would
have been my Telltale clue I'm just not
sending the sport even if the human
typed it in and logically because I've
done this before that must mean I didn't
give the thing a name but another good
tool like good programmers web
developers are using these kinds of
tools all the time they're not writing
bug-free code that's not the point to
get to the point to get to is being a
good diagnostician I would say in these
cases okay other questions on this
I'm sorry sorry a little letter
[Music]
uh so if how would you edit a uh CSS if
you have these templates that process
will actually see before long is almost
going to be the exact same just to give
you a teaser for this and you'll do this
in the problem set but we'll give you
some distribution code to automate this
process you can absolutely still do
something like this link href uh equals
quote unquote Styles dot CSS Rel equals
style sheet that's one of the techniques
we showed last week the only difference
today using flask is that all of your
static files by convention should go in
your static folder so the change you
would make in your layout would be to
say that styles.css is in your static
folder and then if I go into my frosh
IMS directory I can create a static
folder I can CD into it nothing's there
by default but if I now code a file
called styles.css I could now do
something like this body and in here I
could say back ground back uh ground
color say uh
[Music]
ff000 to make it red let me go ahead now
and restart flask in the frosh I am's
directory across my fingers because I'm
doing this on the Fly
go back to my form and reload
voila now we've tied together last
week's stuff as well
if I answered the right question
[Music]
if you want to change one page and not
the other in terms of CSS
that depends in that case you're Pro you
might want to have different CSS files
for each page if they're that different
you could use different classes in one
template than you did in the other
there's different ways to do that you
could even have a placeholder in your
layout that allows you to plug in the
URL of a specific style sheet in your
individual files but that starts to get
more complicated quickly so in short you
can absolutely do it but typically I
would say most websites
try not to use different style sheets
per page they reuse the Styles as much
as they can
okay all right let me go ahead and
revert this real quick and let's start
to add a little bit more functionality
here I'm going to go ahead and just
remove the static folder just so as to
not complicate things just yet and let's
go ahead and just play around with a
different user interface mechanism in my
form here the drop down menu is
perfectly fine nothing wrong with it but
suppose that I wanted to change it to
like check boxes instead maybe I want
students to be able to register for
multiple Sports instead well it might
make sense to clean this up in a couple
of ways and let's do this before we even
get into the check boxes there's one
subtle bad design here notice that I've
hard-coded basketball soccer and
Ultimate Frisbee here and if you recall
an app.pi I also enumerated all three of
those here and anytime you see like copy
paste or the equivalent thereof feels
like we could do better so what if I
instead do this what if I instead give
myself like a global variable of sports
I'll capitalize the word just to connote
that it's meant to be constant even
though python does not have constants
per say the first sport will be
basketball the second will be soccer the
third will be Ultimate Frisbee
now I have one convenient place to store
all of my sports if it changes next
semester or next year or whatnot but
notice what I could do too I could now
do something like this let me pass into
my index template a variable called
sports that's equal to that Global
variable Sports let me go into my index
now and this is really now going to hint
at the power of templating and Jinja in
this case here let me go ahead and get
rid of all three of these hard-coded
options and let me show you some
slightly different Syntax for sport in
sports
then end four
we've not seen this N4 syntax there's
like n block syntax but it's as simple
as that so you have a start and an end
to your block without indentation
mattering watch what I can do here
option uh curly brace sport close curly
brace let me save that let me go back
into my terminal window do flask run and
if I didn't mess up here let me go back
to this the Red's going to go away
because I deleted my CSS and now I still
have a sport drop down and all of those
sports are still there I can make one
more Improvement now I don't need to
mention these same Sports manually in
app.pi I can now just say if the user's
inputted sport is not in my Global
variable Sports and ask the same
question and this is really handy
because if there's another sport for
instance that gets added like say
football all I have to do is change my
Global variable and if I reload the form
now and look in the drop down boom now I
have support for a fourth Sport and I
can keep adding and adding there so
here's where templating starts to get
really powerful in that now in this
template I'm using jinja's for Loop
syntax which is almost identical to
python here except you need the curly
brace and the percent sign and you need
the weird ending and four but it's the
same ideas in Python iterating over
something with a for Loop lets you
generate more and more HTML and this is
like every website out there for
instance Gmail when you visit your inbox
and you see all of this big table of
emails you know Google has not
hard-coded your emails manually they
have grabbed them from a database they
have some kind of for Loop like this and
are just outputting table row after
table row or div after div
dynamically all right so now let's go
ahead and change this maybe to oh how
about uh little uh check boxes or radio
buttons so let me go ahead and do this
instead of a select menu I'm going to go
ahead and do something like this for
each of these Sports let me go ahead and
output not an option but let me go ahead
and output an input tag the name for
which is quote unquote sport the type of
which is check box the value of which is
going to be the current sport quote
unquote and then afterward I need to
redundantly seemingly output the sport
so you see a word next to the checkbox
and we'll look at the result of this in
just a moment so it's actually a little
simpler than a select menu a drop down
menu because now watch what happens if I
reload my form different user interface
and you know it's not as pretty but it's
going to allow users to sign up for
multiple Sports at once now it would
seem now I can click on basketball and
football and soccer or some other
combination thereof if I view the Page's
Source this is again the power of
templating I didn't have to type out
four inputs I got them now automatically
and these things all have the same name
but that's okay it turns out with flask
if it sees multiple values for the same
name it's going to hand them back to you
as a list if you use the right function
all right but suppose we don't want
users registering for multiple Sports
maybe capacity is an issue let me go
ahead and change this checkbox to radio
button which a radio button is mutually
exclusive so you can only sign up for
one so now once I reload the page it now
there we go it now looks like this and
because I've given each of these inputs
the same name quote unquote sport that's
what makes them mutually exclusive the
browser knows all four of these things
are types of sports therefore I'm only
going to let you select one of these
things and that's simply because they
all have the same name again if I view
page Source notice all of them name
equals sport name equals sport name
equal sport but what differs is the
value that each one is going to have
all right any questions then on this
approach
[Music]
all right well let me go ahead and open
a version of this that I made in advance
that's going to now start saving the
information so thus far we're not quite
at the point of where this website was
which actually allowed the Proctors to
see like in a database everyone who had
registered for sports now we're
literally telling students you are
registered or you are not registered but
we're literally doing nothing with this
information so how might we go about
implementing this well let me go ahead
and close these tabs and let me go into
what I called version three of this in
the code for today and let me go into my
source 9 directory froshims3 and let me
go ahead and open up app.pi so this is a
pre-made version I've gotten rid of
football in this case but I've added one
thing at the very top what's in English
does this represent on line seven
what would you describe what that thing
is
[Music]
what are we looking at what do you think
yeah it's an empty dictionary right
registrants is apparently a variable on
the left it's being assigned an empty
dictionary on the right and a dictionary
again is just key value pairs here again
is we're dictionaries are just such a
useful data structure why because this
is going to allow me to remember that
David registered for Ultimate Frisbee
Carter registered for soccer Emma
registered for something else you can
associate keys with values names with
sports assuming a model where you can
only register for one sport for now and
so let's see what the logic is that
handles this
here in my register route in the code
I've pre-made notice that I'm validating
the user's name slightly differently
from before but same idea I'm using
request.form.get to get the human's name
if not name so if the human did not type
a name I'm going to Output
error.html but notice I've started to
make the user interface more expressive
I'm telling the user apparently with a
message what they did wrong well how I'm
apparently passing to my error template
instead of just failure.html a specific
message so let's go down this Rabbit
Hole let me actually go into
template slash error.html and sure
enough here's a new file I created here
that adorably is apparently going to
have a grumpy cat as part of the error
message but notice what I've done in my
block body I've got an H1 tag that just
says error big and bold I then have a
paragraph tag that plugs in whatever the
mirror message is that the controller
app.pi is passing in and then just for
fun I have a picture of a grumpy cat
connoting that there was in fact an
error let's keep looking how do I
validate sport I do similarly
request.form dot get of sport and I
store it in a variable called sport if
there's no such sport that is the human
did not check any of the boxes then I'm
going to render error.html2 but I'm
going to give a different message
missing sport else if the sport they did
type in is not in my sports Global
variable I'm going to render error.html
but complain differently you gave me an
invalid sport somehow they you know as
like a hacker went into the HTML of the
page changed it to add their own sport
like volleyball even though it's not
offered they submitted volleyball but
that's okay I'm rejecting it even though
they might have maliciously tried to
send it to me by changing the Dom
locally and then really the magic is
just this I remembered that this person
is registered by indexing into the
registrants dictionary using the name
the human typed in is the key and
assigning it a value of sport why is
this useful well I added one final route
here I have a slash registrants route
with a registrants function that renders
a template called registrants at HTML
but it takes as input that Global
variable
just like before so let's go down this
Rabbit Hole let me go into
templates
registrants.html here's this template or
it looks a little crazy big but it
extends the layout here comes the body
I've got an H1 tag that says registrants
big and bold then I've got a table that
we saw last week this has a table head
that just says name sport for two
columns then it has a table body where
in using this for Loop in ginger syntax
I'm saying for each name in the
registrants variable output a table row
start tag and end tag inside of which
two table datas two cells table data for
name table data for registrants bracket
name
so it's very similar to python syntax it
essentially is python syntax albeit with
these curly braces and the percent sign
so the net effect here is what let me
open up my terminal window run flask run
let me now go into the form that I
pre-made here so gone is football let me
go ahead and type in David let me choose
oh no sport register
error missing Sport and there is the
grumpy cat so missing sport though
specifically was outputted all right
fine let me go ahead and say uh no name
but I'll choose basketball register
missing name all right let me
maliciously now do this right now I'm
hacking let me go into this I'll type my
name sure but let me go into the body
tag down here let me maliciously go down
in Ultimate Frisbee uh heck with that
let's volleyball change that and change
this to
volleyball league ball enter so now I
can register for any sport I want to
create let me click register but invalid
Sports so again that speaks to the power
and the need for checking things on the
back end and not trusting users it is
that easy to hack websites otherwise if
you're not validating data server side
all right finally let's just do this for
real David is going to register for
Ultimate Frisbee clicking register and
now the output's not very pretty but
notice I'm at the registrants route
and if I zoom out I have an HTML table
two columns name and Sport David and
Ultimate Frisbee let me go back to the
form let me pretend like Carter walked
up to my laptop and registered for
basketball register now we see two rows
in this table David Ultimate Frisbee
Carter basketball and if we do this one
more time maybe Emma comes along and
registers for soccer register all of
this information is being stored in this
dictionary now
all right so that's great now we have a
database albeit in the form of like a
python dictionary but why is this maybe
not the best implementation
why is it not great yeah
[Music]
yeah so we're only storing this
dictionary in the computer's memory and
that's great until I hit Ctrl C and kill
flask stopping the web server or the
server reboots or maybe I close my
laptop or whatever if the server stops
running memory is going to be lost right
Ram is volatile it's thrown away when
you lose power or stop the program so
maybe this isn't the best approach maybe
it would be better to use a CSV file and
in fact some 20 years ago that's
literally what I did I stored everything
in a CSV file but let's skip that step
because we already saw last week or a
couple of weeks ago now how we can use
SQL Lite let's see if we can't marry in
some SQL here to store an actual
database for the program let me go back
here and let me open up say version four
of this which is almost the same but it
adds a bit more functionality let me
close these tabs and let me open up
app.pi now in version four
so notice it's almost the same but at
the top I'm creating a database
connection to a database called
froshims.db so that's a database I
created in advance so let's go down that
rabbit hole what does it look like let
me make my terminal window bigger let me
run SQL Lite 3 of froshims.db okay I'm
in let's do dot schema and let's just
infer what I designed this to be I have
a table called registrants which has one
to three columns an ID column that's an
integer a name column that's text but
cannot be null and a sport column that's
also text cannot be null and the primary
key is just ID so that I have a unique
ID for every registration let's see if
there's anyone in there yet select star
from registrants okay there's no one in
there no one is yet registered for
sports so let's go back to the code and
continue on in my code now I've got the
same Global variable for validation and
generation of my HTML looks like my
index route is the same it's dynamically
gen generating the menu of sports
interestingly we'll come back to this
there's a deregister route that's going
to allow someone to deregister
themselves if they want to exit the
sport or undo their registration but
this is the juicy part here's my new and
improved register route still works on
post so some mild privacy there
I'm validating the submission as follows
I'm getting the user's inputted name the
user's inputted Sport and if it is not a
name or the sport is not in sports I'm
going to render failure.html so I kept
it simple there's no cat in this version
it just says failure otherwise recall
how we co-mingled SQL and python before
we're using cs50s SQL library but that
just makes it a little easier to execute
SQL queries and we're executing this
insert into registrants name comma sport
what two values the name and the sport
that came from that HTML form and then
lastly and this is a new function that
we're calling out explicitly now flask
also gives you access to a redirect
function which is how
um which is how a safetyschool.org
Harvard sucks dot org and those other
sites we played around with last week
were all implemented redirecting the
user from one place to another this
flask function redirect comes from my
just having imported it at the very top
of this file it handles the HTTP 301 or
302 or 307 code whatever the appropriate
one is it does that for me all right so
that's it for Regis that's it for
register ring via this row let's look at
what the slash registrants route is
here we have a new route for Slash
registrants and instead of just
iterating over a dictionary like before
we're getting back let's see db.execute
of Select star from registrants so
that's like literally the programmatic
version of what I just did manually that
gives me back a list of dictionaries
Each of which represents one row in the
table then I'm going to render
registrants.html passing in literally
that list of dictionaries just like
using cs50s library in the past
so let's go and look at these that form
if I go into templates and open up
registrants.html oh okay it's just a
table like before
and actually let me change this
syntactically for consistency
we have a Jinja for Loop that iterates
over each registrant and for each of
them outputs a table row but this is
interesting instead of just having two
columns with the person's name and Sport
notice that I'm also outputting a
full-fledged form all right this is
starting to get kind of Juicy so let's
actually go back to my terminal window
run flask and actually see what this
example looks like now let me reload the
page
all right and the home page looks
exactly the same but let me now register
for something David for Ultimate Frisbee
register
oh damn it uh
never let's try this again David
registering for Ultimate Frisbee
register
okay so good thing I have deregister so
this is what it should now look like I
have a page at the route called slash
registrants that has a table with two
columns name and Sport David ultimate
freeze people oh wait a third column why
because if I view the page Source notice
that it's not the prettiest UI for every
Row in this table I'm also going to be
outputting a form just to deregister
that user but before we see how that
works let me go ahead and register
Carter for instance so Carter will give
you basketball again register the table
grows now let me go back and let's
register Emma for soccer and the table
should grow
before we look at that HTML let's go
back to my a terminal window let's go
into SQL Lite frosh IMS uh
let me go into
frosh IMS and let me open up with SQL
Lite three
froshims.db and now do select star from
registrants and whereas previously when
I executed this there were zero people
now
there's indeed three so now we see
exactly what's going on underneath the
hood
so let's look at this form now at this
page now if I want to unregister
deregister one of these people
specifically
how do we do this
clicking those one of those buttons will
indeed delete the row from the database
but how do we go about linking a web
page with python code with a database
like this is the last piece of the
puzzle up until now everything's been
with forms and also with URLs but what
if the user is not typing anything in
they're just clicking a button
well watch this
let me go ahead and sniff the traffic
which you could be in the habit of doing
now anytime you're curious how a website
works let me go to the network Tab and
uh Carter shall we deregister you from
basketball
let's deregister Carter and let's see
what just happened if I look at the
deregister request notice that it's a
post the status code that eventually
came back is 302 but let's look at the
request itself all the headers there
will ignore
the only thing that button submits kind
of cleverly is an ID parameter a key
equaling two what is two presumably
represent or map to
like where did this two come from
it doesn't say Carter it doesn't say
basketball
what is it
the second person that registered so
those primary keys that we started
talking about a couple of weeks ago why
it's useful to be able to uniquely
identify a row and a table here is just
one of the reasons why if it suffices
for me just to send the ID number of the
person I want to delete from the
database because I can then have code
like this if I go into app.pi
and I look at my deregister route now
the last of them notice that I got this
I first go into the form and I get the
ID that was submitted hopefully if there
was in fact an ID and the form wasn't
somehow empty I execute this line of
code delete from registrants where ID
equals question mark and then I plug in
that number deleting Carter and only
Carter and I'm not using his name
because what if we have two people named
Carter two people named Emma or David
you don't want to delete both of them
that's why these unique IDs are so
so important and here's another reason
why you don't want to store some things
in URLs suppose we
went to this URL D register question
mark ID equals three suppose I
maliciously
emailed this URL to Emma it doesn't
matter so much what the beginning is but
suppose I emailed her this URL slash
deregister question mark ID equals three
and I said hey Emma click this
and it uses get instead of post what did
I just trick her into doing
what's going to happen if Emma clicks
this yeah
you would trick her into de-registering
herself why because if she's logged into
this frosh I am's website and the URL
contains her ID just because I'm being
malicious and she clicked on it and the
website is using get unfortunately get
URLs are again staple they have state
information in the URLs and in this case
it's enough to delete the user and boom
she would have accidentally deregistered
herself and this is pretty innocuous
suppose that this was her bank account
trying to make a withdrawal or a deposit
suppose that this were some other
website a Facebook URL trying to trick
her into posting something automatically
here too is another consideration when
you should use post versus get because
get requests can be plugged into emails
sent via slack message messages text
messages or the like and unless there's
a prompt saying are you sure you want to
deregister yourself you might blindly
trick the user into being vulnerable to
what's called a cross-site request
forgery a fancy way of saying you trick
them into clicking a link that they
shouldn't have because the web website
was using get alone
all right any question then on these
building blocks
[Music]
when three columns you mean
uh the three forward slashes I'm not
sure I follow
[Music]
sorry it's in where
which file
[Music]
sorry the other direction
okay
[Music]
it keeps growing more oh this thing okay
sorry
um this is just a this is uh a URI
that's refer that's typical syntax
that's referring to the SQL light
protocol so to speak which means use SQL
Lite to talk to a file locally colon
slash slash is just like you and I see
in URLs the third slash essentially
means current folder that's all so it's
it's a weird curiosity um but it's
typical whenever you're referring to a
local file and not one that's Elsewhere
on the internet that's a bit of an
oversimplification but that's indeed a
convention sorry for not that not
clicking earlier all right let's do one
other iteration of frosh IMS here just
to show what I was actually doing too
back in the day was not only storing
these things in CSV files as I recall I
was also automatically generating an
email to the Proctor in charge of the
intramural sports program so they would
have sort of a running history of people
registering and they could easily reply
to them as well let me go into frosh I
am version 5 which I pre-created here
and let me go ahead and open up say
app.pi this time and this is some code
that I wrote in advance and it looks a
little scary at first glance but I've
done the following I have now added the
flask mail library to the picture by
adding flaskmail to requirements.txt and
running a command to automatically
install email support for flask as well
and this is a little bit cryptic but
it's honestly mostly copy paste from the
documentation what I'm doing here is I'm
configuring my flask application with a
few configuration variables if you will
this is the Syntax for that app.config
is a special dictionary that comes with
flask that is automatically created when
you create the app up here on line nine
and I just had to fill in a whole bunch
of configuration values for the default
sender address that I want to send email
as the default password I want to use to
send email the port number the TCP Port
that we talked about last week the mail
server I'm going to use Gmail's
smtp.gmail.com server use TLS this means
use encryption and so I set that to True
mail username this is going to grab it
from my environment so for security
purposes I didn't want to hard code my
own Gmail username and password into the
code so I'm actually storing those in
what are called environment variables
you'll see more of these in problem sets
nine and it's a very common convention
on a server in the real world to store
sensitive information in the computer's
memory so that it can be accessed when
your website is running but not in your
source code it's way too easy if you put
credentials sensitive stuff in your
source code to post it to GitHub or to
screenshot it accidentally or for
information to leak out so for today's
purposes know that the OS dot Environ
dictionary refers to what are called
environment variables and this is like
an out of band a special way of defining
key value pairs in the computer's memory
by running a certain command but that
never show up in your actual code
otherwise there would be so many
usernames and passwords accidentally
visible on the internet so I've
installed this in advance let me see if
I can do this correctly let me go over
to another tab in just a moment
and here I have on my second screen here
John Harvard's inbox it's currently
empty and I'm going to go ahead and
register for some Sport AS John Harvard
here hopefully so let me go ahead and
run flask run on this version 5.
let me go ahead and reload the main
screen not that one let me reload the
main screen here this time clearly I'm
asking for name and email so name will
be John Harvard
Jay harbored at
cs50.harvard.edu
he'll register for about soccer
register
and if I did this correctly not only is
John Harvard on his screen seeing you
are registered but when he checks his
email
on this other screen
Crossing his fingers that this actually
works as a demonstration
[Music]
promise it did right before class
fortifying
I don't think there's a mistake this
time
let me try something over here real
quick but I don't think this is broken
it wouldn't have said success if it were
I just tried submitting again so I just
did another Ur registered
[Music]
well I'm really sad right now
what's that
I could check spam but then it's
foreign
not sure we want to show spam here on
the internet that every one of us gets
oh maybe
oh
okay wow that was a risky click I
worried all right so you are registered
is the email that I sent out and it
doesn't have any actual information in
it but back in the day it would have
because I included like the student's
name in their dorm and all the other
fields of information that we asked for
so let's just take a quick look at how
that code might work I did have to
configure Gmail in a certain way to
allow what they call less secure apps
using SMTP which is the protocol used
for outbound email but besides setting
these things let's look at the register
route down here it's actually pretty
straightforward in my register route I
validated the submission just like
before nothing new there I then
confirmed the registration down here
nothing new there all I did was use two
new lines of code and it's this easy to
automate the sending of emails I
apparently have done it too many times
which is why it ended up in spam I
created a variable called message I used
a message function that I must have
imported higher up so we'll go back to
that here's apparently the subject line
as the first argument and the second
argument is the uh named parameter
recipients which takes a list of emails
that should get the confirmation email
so in brackets I just put the one user's
email and then mail.send that message so
let's scroll back up to see what message
uh and what mail actually is mail I
think we saw yep male is this which I
have as a variable because I followed
the documentation for this Library you
simply configure your current app with
mail support capital M here and if you
look up here now on line seven here's
the new library from flaskmail I
imported Capital mail Capital message so
that I had the ability to create a
message and send a mail so such a simple
thing whether you want to confirm things
for users you want to do password resets
it can be this easy to actually generate
emails provided you have the requisite
access and software installed and just
to make clear that I did add something
here let me open up my requirements.txt
file and indeed I have both flask and
flask Dash mail
ready to go but I ran the command in
advance to actually do that all right
any questions then
on these examples here
no all right so what other pieces might
actually remain for us let me flip over
here it turns out that a key component
of most any web application nowadays
that we haven't touched on yet but it'll
be one of our final flourishes today is
the notion of a session and a session is
actually a feature that derives from all
of the basics we talked about today and
last week and a session is the technical
term for like what you and I know as a
shopping cart when you go to amazon.com
and you start adding things to your
shopping cart they follow you from page
to page to page Heck if you close your
browser come back to the next day
they're typically still in your shopping
cart which is great for Amazon because
they want your business they don't want
you have to like start from scratch the
next day similarly when you log into any
website these days even if it's not an
e-commerce thing but it has usernames
and passwords you and I are not in the
habit of logging into every darn page we
visit on a website typically you log in
once and then for the next hour day week
year you stay logged into that website
so somehow the website site is
remembering that you have logged in and
that is being implemented by way of this
thing called a session and perhaps a
more familiar term that you might know
as and worry about called cookies let's
go ahead and take one more five minute
break here and when we come back we'll
look at cookies sessions and these final
features
all right so the promise now is that
we're going to implement this notion of
a session which is going to allow us to
like log users in and keep them logged
in and even Implement things like a
shopping cart and the overarching goal
here is to build an application that is
quote unquote stateful Again State
refers to information and something
that's stateful remembers information
and in this context the curiosity is
that HTTP is technically a stateless
protocol like once you visit a URL HTTP
colon slash something hit enter web page
is downloaded to your browser like
that's it like you can unplug from the
internet you can turn off your Wi-Fi but
you still have the web page locally and
yet we somehow want to make sure that
the next time you click on a link on
that website it doesn't forget who you
are or the next thing you add to your
shopping cart it doesn't forget what was
already there so we somehow want to make
HTTP stateful and we can actually do
this using the building blocks we've
seen thus far so concretely here's like
a form you might see occasionally but
pretty rarely when you log into Gmail
right and I say kind of rarely because
most of you don't log into Gmail
frequently you just stay logged in
pretty much endlessly in your browser
and that's because Google has made the
conscious choice to give you a very long
session time maybe a day a week a month
a year because they don't really want to
add friction to using their tool and
making you log in every darn Day by
contrast there's other applications on
on campus including some of cs50 Zone
that makes you log in every time because
we want to make sure that it's indeed
you accessing the site and not a
roommate or friend or someone
maliciously so once you do fill out this
form how does Google subsequently know
that you are you and when you reload the
page even or open a second tab for your
same Gmail account how do they know that
you're still David or Carter or Emma or
someone else well let's look underneath
the hood of what's going on when you log
into Gmail
essentially you initially see a form
like this using a get request and the
website responds like we saw last week
with some kind of HTTP response
hopefully two 200 okay with the form
meanwhile the website might also respond
with an HTTP header that last week we
didn't care about this week we now do
whenever you visit a website it is very
commonly the case that the website is
putting a cookie on your computer and
you may generally know that cookies can
be bad and they kind of track you in
some way and that's both a a blessing
and a curse without cookies you could
not Implement things like shopping carts
and logins as we know them today
unfortunately they can also be used for
ill purposes like tracking you on every
website and serving you ads more
effectively and so forth so with good
comes some bad but the basic primitive
for us the computer scientist boils down
to just HTTP headers a cookie is
typically a big number a big seemingly
random value that a server tells your
browser to store in memory or even
longer term store on disk so you can
think of it like a file that a server is
planting on your computer and the
promise us that HTTP makes is that if a
server sets a cookie on your computer
you will represent that same cookie or
that same value on every subsequent
request so when you visit the website
like Gmail they plop a cookie on your
computer like this with some session
equals value some wrong random value one
two three ABC or something like that and
when you then visit another page on
gmail.com or any other website you send
the opposite header not set cookie but
just cookie colon and you send the exact
same value it's similar to going to a
club or an amusement park where you pay
once you go through the gates once you
get checked by security once and then
they you know very often take a like a
little stamp and say okay now you can
come and go and then for you efficiency
wise if you come back later in the day
or later in the evening you can just
present your hand you've been stamped
presumably they've already you've
already paid you've already been
searched or whatnot and so it's this
sort of Fast Track ticket back into the
club back into the park that's
essentially what a cookie is doing for
you whereby it's a way of reminding the
website we've already done this you
already asked me for my username and
password this is my past to now come and
go now unlike this hand stamp which can
you know kind of be easily copied or
transferred or duplicated or you know
kept on over multiple days these cookies
are really big seemingly random values
letters and numbers so statistically
there's no way someone else is just
going to guess your cookie value and
pretend to be you it's just very low
probability statistically but this is
all it boils down to is this agreement
between browser and server to send these
values back and forth in this way so
when we actually translate this now to
code let's do something like a simple
login app let me go into a folder I made
in advance today called login and let me
code up
app.pi and let's take a look in here
so what's going on a couple of new
things up top if I want to have the
ability to stamp my users hands
virtually and Implement sessions I'm
going to have to import from flask
support for sessions so this is another
feature you get for free by using a
framework and not having to implement
all this yourself and from the flask
session Library I'm going to import
session capital S why I'm going to
configure this session as follows long
story short there's different ways to
implement sessions the server can store
these cookies in a database in a file in
memory and RAM in other places too we
are telling it to store these cookies on
the server's hard drive so in fact
whenever you use sessions as you will
for problem set 9 you'll actually see a
folder suddenly appear called flask
underscore session inside of which are
the cookies essentially for any users or
friends or yourself who've been visiting
your particular application so I'm
setting it to use the file system and I
don't want them to be permanent because
I want when you close your browser the
session to go away they could be made to
be permanent and last much longer then I
tell my app to support sessions and
that's it for now let's see what this
application actually does before we
dissect the code let me go over to my
terminal window run flask run
and then let me go ahead and reload
my preview URL
give it a second to kick back in
let me go ahead and open my URL come on
oops let me go ahead
too long of a break there we go so this
website simply has a login form there's
no password though I could certainly add
that and check for that too it just asks
for your name so I'm going to log in as
myself David and click login and now
notice I'm currently at the slash login
route but notice this if I try to go to
the default route just slash which is
where most websites live by default
notice that I magically get redirected
to log in so somehow my code knows hey
if you're not logged in you're going to
slash login instead let me type in my
name David and click login and now
notice I am back at slash Chrome is sort
of annoyingly hiding it but this is the
same thing as just a single slash and
now notice it says you are logged in as
David log out what's kind of cool is
notice if I reload the page it still
knows that if I create a second Tab and
go to the same URL it still knows that I
could even
um I could keep doing this in multiple
types it's still going to remember me on
both of them as being logged in as David
so how does that work especially when I
click log out then I get uh forgotten
altogether all right so let's see how
this works and some basic building
blocks under my slash route notice I
have this
if there is no name in the session
redirect the user to slash login so
these two lines together are what
Implement that automatic redirection
using HTTP 301 or 302 automatically it's
handled for me with these two lines
otherwise show index.html all right
let's go down that rabbit hole what's in
index.html well if I look in
my let me look in my templates folder
uh for my login demo and look at
template slash index.html
all right so what's going on here I
extend layout.html I have a block body
and then I've got some other syntax so
we haven't seen this yet but it's more
Ginger stuff which again is almost
identical to python if there's a name in
the session variable then literally say
you are logged in as curly braces
session bracket name and then notice
this I've got a simple HTML link to log
out via slash logout else if there is no
name in the session then it apparently
says you are not logged in and it leads
me to an HTML link to slash login and
then end diff so again Jinja does not
rely on indentation recall the HTML and
CSS don't really care about indentation
only the human does but in code with
Jinja you need these end tags and block
N4 and if to make super obvious that
you're done with that thought
so session is just this magic variable
that we now have access to because we've
included these two lines of code and
these that handle that whole process of
stamping every user's hand with a
different unique identifier if I made my
code space public and I let all of you
visit the exact same URL all of you
would be logged out by default you could
all type your own names individually all
log in at the same URL using different
sessions and in fact I would then see if
I go into my terminal window here and my
login directory notice the flask session
directory I mentioned and if I C D into
that and type LS notice that I had two
tabs open or actually I think I started
the server twice I have two files in
there I would ultimately have one file
for every one of you and that's what's
beautiful about sessions is it creates
the illusion of per user storage inside
of my session is my name inside of your
session so to speak is your name and the
same is going to apply to shopping cart
ultimately as well let's see how login
works here my login route supports both
get and post so I could play around if I
want and notice this this login route is
kind of interesting as follows if the
user got to this route via post my
inference is that they must have
submitted a form why because that's what
how I'm going to design the HTML form in
a second and if they did submit the form
via post I'm going to store in the
session at the name key whatever the
human's name is and then I'm going to
redirect them back to slash otherwise
I'm going to show them the login form so
this is what's kind of cool if I go to
this login form which lives at literally
slash login by default when you visit a
URL like that you're visiting a via get
and so that's why I see the form however
notice this the form very cleverly
submits to itself like the one route
slash login submits to its same self
slash login but it uses post when you
submit the form and this is a nice way
of having one route but for two
different types of operations or views
when I'm just there visiting slash login
via a URL it shows me the form but if I
submit the form then this logic these
three lines kick in and this just avoids
my having to have both an index route
and a greet route for instance I can
just have one route that handles both
get
and post how about logout what does this
do well it's as simple as this change
whatever name is in the session to be
none which is Python's version of like
null essentially and then redirect the
user back to slash because now in
index.html I will not notice a name
there anymore this will be false and so
I'll tell the user instead you are not
logged in
so like it's I want to say as simple as
this is though I realize this is a bunch
of steps involved this is the essence of
every website on the internet that has
usernames and passwords and we skip the
password name step for that more on that
in problem set nine but this is how
every website out there remembers that
you're logged in and how this works
ultimately is that as soon as you use in
Python lines like this and lines like
this flasks takes care of stamping the
virtual hand of all of your users and
whenever flask sees the same cookie
coming back from a user it grabs the
appropriate file from that folder loads
it into the session Global variable so
that your code is now unique to that
user and their name
let's do one other example with sessions
here that'll show how we might use these
now for shopping carts let me go into
the store example here let me go ahead
and run this thing first if I run store
in my same Tab and go back over here
we'll see a very ugly e-commerce site
that just sells seven different books
here but each of these books has a
button via which I can add it to my cart
all right well where are these books
coming from let's kind of poke around
let me go into my terminal window again
let me go into this example which is
called store and let me open up about uh
index.ht whoops let's open up index
how about
books.html is the default one not Index
this time so if I look here notice that
that route that we just saw uses a for
Loop in Jinja to iterate over a whole
bunch of books apparently and it outputs
in an H2 tag the title of the book and
then another one of these forms so
that's kind of interesting let's go back
one step let's go ahead and open up
app.pi because that must be excuse me
what's kicking all of this off notice
that this file is importing session
support it's configuring sessions down
here but it's also connecting to a
store.db file so it's adding some SQL
light and notice this in my slash route
I'm selecting star from books which is
going to give me a list of dictionaries
Each of which represents a row of books
and I'm going to pass that list of books
into my books.html template which is why
this for Loop works the way it does
let's look at this actual database let
me increase my terminal window and do
SQL Lite of store.db e dot schema will
show me everything there's not much
there it's a book it's a table called
books with two columns ID and title
let's do select star from books
semicolon there are the seven books Each
of which has a unique ID and you might
see where this is going if I go to the
UI and I look at each of these buttons
for add to cart just like Amazon might
have notice that each of these buttons
is just a form and what's magical here
just like deregister even though I
didn't highlight it at the time there's
another type of input that allows you to
specify a value without the human being
able easily to change it instead of type
equals text or type equals submit type
equals hidden will put the value in the
form but not reveal it to the user so
that's how I'm saying that the ID of
this book is one the idea of this book
is two the idea of this book is three
and so forth and each of these forms
then will submit apparently to slash
cart using post and that would seem to
be what adds things to cart so let's try
this let me click on one or two of these
let's add the first book add to cart
here's my cart notice my route changed
to slash cart all right let's go back
and let's add the book number two
there we have that one and let's skip
ahead to the seventh book Deathly
Hallows and how now we have all three
books here so what does the cart route
do at slash cart well let's look if I go
back to my terminal window look at
app.pi and look at slash cart okay
there's a lot going on here but let's
let's see so the slash cart route
supports both get or post which is a
nice way to consolidate things into one
URL
all right this is interesting if there
is not a quote-unquote cart key in
session we haven't technically seen the
syntax but long story short these lines
here do ensure that the cart exists what
do I mean by that it makes sure that
there's a cart key in the session Global
variable and it's by default going to be
an empty list why that just means you
have an empty shopping cart but if the
user visits this route via post
and the user did provide an ID they
didn't muck with the form in any way and
like try to hack into the website they
gave me a valid ID then I'm going to use
this syntax if session bracket cart is a
list recall from a couple of weeks ago
that dot append just adds something to
the list so I'm going to add the ID to
the list and return the user to cart
otherwise if the user is at slash cart
via get implicitly we just do this
select star from books where ID is in
and this might be syntax you recall from
pset 6 it lets you look for multiple IDs
all at once because if I have a list of
session a list of IDs in my cart I can
get all of those books at once so long
story short what has happened here I am
storing in the cart
the books that I myself have added to my
cart my browser is sending the same
handstamp again and again which is how
this website knows that it's me adding
these books to my cart and not you or
not Carter or not Emma indeed if all of
us visited the same long URL and I made
it public and allowed that then we would
all have our own illusions of our own
separate carts and each of those carts
in practice would just be stored in this
flask session directory on the server so
that the server can keep track of each
of us using again these cookie values
that are being sent back and forth via
these headers
all right I know that's a lot but again
it's just the new python way of just
leveraging those HTTP headers from last
week in a clever way
any questions before we look at one
final
set of examples yeah
[Music]
so I think you're asking about using the
get and post in the same function so
this is just a nice uh aesthetic if you
will if I had to have separate routes
forget in post I mean it literally might
mean I need twice as many routes in my
file and it just starts to get a little
Annoying and these days too in terms of
user experience this is you know maybe
only appeals to The Geek in us but like
having clean URLs is actually a thing
like you don't want to have lots of
words in the URL it's nice if the URLs
are nice and succinct and canonical if
you will so it's nice if I can
centralize all of my shopping cart
functionality in slash cart only and not
in multiple routes one forget one for
post it's a little you know a nitpicky
of me but this is a commonly done here
so what this code here means is that
this route this function henceforth will
support both get requests and post
requests but then I kind of need to
distinguish between whether it's get or
post coming in because if it's a get
request I want to show the cart if it's
a post request I want to update the cart
and the simplest way to do that is just
to check this value here in the request
variable that we imported from flask up
above you can check what is the current
type of request is it a get is it a post
or is it something else altogether there
are other verbs if it's a post that must
mean because I created the web form that
uses post that the user clicked the add
to cart button
otherwise if it's not post it's
implicitly going to be logically get
then I just want to show the user the
contents of the cart and I use these
lines instead so it's just one way of
avoiding having two routes for two
different HTTP verbs you can combine
them so long as you have a check like
this if I really wanted to be pedantic I
could do this uh L if or L if request
dot method equals gets this would be
more symmetric but it's not really
necessary because I know there's only
two possibilities
hope that helps
all right let's do one final set of
examples here that's going to tie the
last of these features together to
something that you probably see quite
often in real world applications and
that For Better or For Worse is now
going to involve tying back in some
JavaScript from last week the goal at
hand of these examples is not to
necessarily Master how you yourself
would write the python code the SQL code
the JavaScript code but just to give you
a mental model for how these different
languages work so that for final
projects especially if you do want to
add JavaScript functionality much more
interactive user interface you at least
have like the bare bones of a mental
model for how you can tie these
languages together even though our Focus
generally has been more on Python and
SQL than on JavaScript from last week
let me go ahead and open up an example
called shows version zero of this and
let me do flask run and let me go into
my URL here and see what this
application looks like by default this
has just a simple query text box with a
search box let's take a look at the HTML
that just got sent to my browser all
right there's not much going on here at
all so there's a form whose action is
slash search it's going to submit via
get it's going to use a q parameter just
like Google it seems and submit it so
this actually looks like the Google form
we did last week so let's see what what
goes on here let me search for something
like cat
enter
okay so it looks like all right so this
is actually a somewhat familiar file
what I've gone ahead and done is I've
grabbed all of the titles of TV shows
from a couple of weeks ago when we first
introduced SQL and I loaded them into
this demo so that you can search by
keyword for any word you want I just
searched for cat if we were to do this
again we would see all the title of TV
shows that contain dog
as a substring somewhere and so forth so
this is a traditional way of doing this
just like in Google it uses slash search
question mark Cube equals cat Q equals
dog and so forth how does that work well
let's just take a quick look at app.pi
here
let me go into my zero example here show
zero and open up app.pi and see what's
going on all right very simple here's
the form that's kind of how we started
today and here is the slash search route
well what's going on here this gets a
little interesting so I first select a
whole bunch of shows by doing this
select star from shows where title like
question mark and then I'm using some
percent signs from SQL on both the left
and the right and I'm plugging in
whatever the user's input was for Q if I
didn't use like and I used equal instead
I could get rid of these curly these
percent signs but then it would have to
be a show called cat or call dog as
opposed to it being like cat or like dog
this whole line returns to me a list of
dictionaries Each of which represents a
show in the database and then I'm
passing all of those shows to a template
called search.html so let's just follow
that breadcrumb let's open up so dot uh
sorry search.html
all right so this is where templating
gets kind of cool so I just passed back
hundreds of results potentially but the
only thing I'm outputting is an
unordered list and using a ginger for
Loop An Li tag containing the titles of
each of those shows and just to prove
that this is indeed a familiar data set
and I actually simplified it a bit if I
look at shows.db with SQL Lite I threw
away all the other stuff like ratings
and actors and everyone else and I just
have for instance select select star
from shows limit 10 just so we can see
10 of them there's 10 of the shows from
that database so that's all that's in
the database itself so it would look
like this is a pretty vanilla web
application it uses get it submits it to
the server the server spits out a
response and that response then looks
like this which is a huge number of Li
tags one for each cat or one for each
dog match but everything else comes from
a layout.html all the stuff at the top
and at the bottom all right so these
days though we're in the habit of seeing
autocomplete and you start typing
something and you don't have to hit
submit you don't have to click a button
you don't have to go to a new page web
applications nowadays are much more
Dynamic so let's take a look at this
version one of this thing let me go into
shows one
and close my previous tabs and run flask
run in here and it's almost the same
thing but watch the behavior change a
little bit I'm reloading the form
there's no button now so gone is the
need for a submit button I want to
implement autocomplete now so let's go
ahead and type in C okay there's every
show that starts with C A there's every
show that has C A in it rather T there's
every show with cat in it I can start it
again and do dog but notice how
instantaneous it was and notice my URL
never changed there's no slash search
route and it's just immediate like with
every keystroke it is searching again
and again and again that's kind of a
nice ux user experience because it's
immediate this is what users are used to
these days but if I look at the source
code here
notice that in the core source code
there's just an empty UL by default but
there is some fancy JavaScript code so
let's see what's going on here this
JavaScript code is doing the following
let me zoom in a little bit more
this JavaScript code is first selecting
with query selector which you used this
past week quote unquote input all right
so that's just getting the text box then
it's adding an event listener to that
input for the input event we didn't talk
about this last week but literally when
you provide any kind of input by typing
by pasting by
any other user interface mechanism it
triggers an event called input so
similar to key press or key up I then
have a function no worries about this
async function for now then what do I do
inside of this all right so this is new
and this is the part that let's just
focus on the ideas and not the syntax
JavaScript nowadays comes with a
function called Fetch that allows you to
get or post information to a server
without reloading the whole page you can
sort of secretly do it inside of the
page what do I want to fetch slash
search question mark Q equals whatever
the value of that input is when I get
back a response I want to get the text
of that response and store it in a
variable called shows and I'm
deliberately bouncing around ignoring
special words like a weight and a weight
here but for now just focus on what came
back a response came back from the
server I'm getting the text from it
storing it in a variable called shows
what am I then doing I'm using query
selector to select my UL which is empty
by default and I'm changing its inner
HTML to be equal to the shows that came
back from the server so let's poke
around here's where again developer
tools are quite powerful let me go ahead
and reload this page to get rid of
everything
and let me now
open up inspect let me go to the network
Tab and let's just sniff the traffic
going between my browser and server I'm
going to search for C notice that
immediately triggered an HTTP request to
slash search question mark Q equals c so
I didn't even finish my cat thought but
notice what came back a bunch of
response headers but let's actually
click on the raw response
this is literally the response from the
server just a whole bunch of Li tags no
UL no HTML no title no body nothing just
Li tags and we can actually simulate
this let me manually go to that same URL
Q equals c enter we are just going to
get back whoops sorry
slash search Q equals c we are just
going to get back this stuff which I've
used Source it's not even a complete web
page the browser is trying to show it to
me as a complete web page with bullets
but it's really just partial HTML but
that's perfect because this is literally
what I essentially want my python code
to copy paste into the otherwise empty
UL tag and that's what this JavaScript
code then
here is doing once it gets back that
response from the server it's using
these lines of code to plug all of those
Lis into the UL after the fact again
changing the so-called Dom
but there's a slightly better way to do
this because honestly this is not the
best design because if you've got a
hundred shows or more you're sending all
of these tags unnecessarily like why do
I need to send all of these stupid HTML
tags why don't I just create those when
I'm ready to create them well here's the
final flourish whenever making a web
application nowadays where client and
server keep talking to one another
Google Maps does this Gmail does this
like literally every cool application
nowadays you load the page once and then
it keeps on interacting with you without
you reloading or having to change the
url
let's actually use a format called Json
JavaScript object notation which is to
say there's just a better more efficient
better designed way to send that same
data I'm going to go into shows 2 now
and do flask run
and I'm going to go back to my page here
the user interface is exactly the same
and it still works exactly the same
here's c c a c a t and so forth but
let's see what's coming back now if I go
to slash search question mark Q equals
cat enter
notice that I get this crazy looking
syntax but the fact that it's so compact
is actually kind of a good thing this is
actually going to let me format it a
little nicer well or a little worse this
is what's called JavaScript object
notation in JavaScript and uh angle a
square bracket means Here Comes an array
in JavaScript a curly bracket says here
comes an object AKA a dictionary and you
might recall from uh
did we do use kind of sort of recall
that you can now have keys and values in
JavaScript notation using colons like
this so long story short cryptic as this
is to you and me and not very human
friendly it's very machine friendly
because for every title in that database
I get back its ID and its title its ID
and its title its ID and its title and
this is a very generic format that an
API an application programming interface
might return to you and this is how apis
nowadays work you get back very raw
textual data in this format Json format
and then you can write code that
actually programmatically turns that
Json data into any language you want for
instance HTML so here's the third and
final version of this program I again
select my input I again listen for input
I then when I get input call this
function I fetch slash search Q equal
tools whatever that input was C or C A
or c a t i then wait for the response
but instead of getting text I'm calling
this other function that comes with
JavaScript these days called Json that
just parses that it turns it into a
dictionary forming or really a list of
dictionaries for me and stores it in a
variable called shows and this is where
you start to see the convergence of HTML
with JavaScript let me initialize a
variable called HTML to nothing quote
unquote using single quotes but I could
also use double quotes this is
Javascript Syntax for a loop let me
iterate over every ID in the shows list
that I just got back in the server that
big chunk of Json data let me create a
variable called title that's equal to
the shows the title of the show at that
ID but for reasons we'll come back to
let me replace a couple scary characters
then let me dynamically add to this
variable An Li tag the actual title and
a close Li tag and then very lastly
after this for Loop let me update the
ul's inner HTML to be the HTML I just
created on the fly so in short don't
worry too much about the syntax because
you won't need to use this unless you
start playing with more advanced
features uh quite soon but what we're
doing is with JavaScript we're creating
a bigger and bigger and bigger string of
HTML containing all of the Open brackets
the LI tags the close brackets but we're
just grabbing the raw data from the
server and so in fact in problem set 9
you're going to use a real world
third-party API application programming
interface for which you sign up the data
you're going to get back from that API
is not going to be show titles but
actually stock quotes and in stocks
ticker symbols and the prices of last uh
at which stocks were last bought or sold
and you're going to get that data back
in Json format and you're going to write
a bit of code that's then going to
convert that to the requisite HTML on
the page so the final result here is
literally the kind of autocomplete that
you and I see and take for granted every
day and that's ultimately how it works
HTML and CSS are used to present the
data your so-called view python might be
used to actually send or get the data on
the backend server and then lastly
JavaScript is going to be used to make
things Dynamic and interactive so I know
that's a whole bunch of building blocks
but the whole point of problem set nine
is to tie everything together set the
stage for hopefully a very successful
final project why don't we go ahead and
wrap up there and we'll see you one last
time next week for emoji
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50 and this is week 10 our
very last together before we dive in
today
um just wanted to acknowledge how much
work we know this course is for for
everyone we know there's still a tad bit
of work remaining but we do hope
ultimately that you're really proud of
what you've pulled off over the past few
months only and indeed the final project
whatever it is you end up building
really is meant to be this Capstone
where you're finally standing on your
own there's no distribution code there's
not really a specification and really
just an opportunity to take all this
knowledge out now for a spin and we do
hope it serves you well longer term
before we dive into just wanted to offer
a number of thanks for so much of the
team that helps out behind the scenes in
particular the Memorial Hall team our
hosts here who make all of the space and
the activities behind the scenes
possible the education Support Services
team who helps with audio and video and
more and then especially cs50's own team
all here in the darkness helping out in
front of the camera behind the camera if
we could a huge round of applause for
for everyone that makes this possible
you might have noticed that these have
been unusual times and we've had some
unusual guests in the front of the room
here since we weren't sure what to
expect early on as to just what
protocols would be on campus and so we
have of course all of these plush
figures behind the scenes who have been
helping out uh behind the camera behind
the monitors and so forth and what many
of you'll see if you've been watching
right now or in the future of these
videos online you'll see a lot of backs
of heads so that there's a little bit of
characteristic to some of the shots that
we have here but this is actually born
of an inspiration that comes from who
will be ultimately today's special guest
Jennifer a Lee in fact when we'll meet
in just a little bit was ultimately the
good friend of the class that inspired
this tradition of using puppetry in some
form in the class here what I see down
below is is a shot like this here and
funny enough it seems that with machine
learning what it is nowadays artificial
intelligence so to speak on social media
media and the like like literally no
joke I pulled up Twitter earlier today
and among my suggestions for whom I
should follow now were literally the
suggestions here
um this is uh perhaps not surprising
though because some weeks back I
actually started following uh count Von
count whom you might remember from
Sesame Street if you're not following
him already this is an amazing account
to follow an actual count to follow I
mean it's actually an amazing use of
programming so this account joined in
April of 2012. it's got 198 000
followers out of after uh as of today
and what it's been doing for like nine
plus years is tweeting out a number one
per day this morning's was 3 300 uh
twenty three three thousand three
hundred twenty seven yesterday's was 3
326. and so presumably someone's just
written a program python or something
else that's just generating these tweets
once a day even more amusing though is
that like every tweet for the past nine
years has like 20 or 30 comments on it
from people who are following it so
perhaps consider following this same
account and the same application of Cs
as well wanted to also thank cs50's team
behind the cameras you might recall uh
the teaching fellows last year in
particular when everything was on Zoom
kindly put together this visualization
of tcpip and the passage passing of
messages among routers and in turn
computers for instance from Phyllis at
bottom right to Brian at top left just
wanted to thank the team but also reveal
to you all that uh these takes were not
perfect by any means and in fact here's
just 60 seconds or so of outtakes of us
trying to get data from point A to point
B
foreign
[Music]
if we could to a round of applause for
all the teaching fellows teaching
assistants and course assistants
who make the course possible
as well before we now do a bit of review
of the semester thought we'd take first
a higher level view of where we've come
from recall of course from the syllabus
and literally week zero we claim this
that what ultimately matters in this
course is not so much where you Rend up
relative to classmates but where you end
up relative to yourself when you begin
and we really do mean that there are
certainly classmates of yours who have
been programming since they are 10 years
old but there are two-thirds of your
classmates who were not in fact that
case and so behind you in front of you
to the left and to the right today are
so many classmates who have had a very
shared experience with you but the only
person that really matters at the end of
the day in terms of how you've
progressed in this class truly is where
you in fact began and I realized that
with cs and especially this course and
with programming assignments especially
it can feel like week after week that
you're not really making progress
because it might feel like you're
struggling every darn week but that's
just really because we kind of keep
moving the bar higher and higher pushing
the Finish Line a little further and
further ahead because think back to like
week one when this for instance whoops
when this alone was hard and you were
just trying to get Mario to ascend a
pyramid that might look a little
something like this or the week after
when you started dabbling with
readability or two weeks after Mr and
Mrs dursley of number four Private Drive
and so forth trying to analyze just how
complex a sentence like that was and
manipulating strings and characters for
the first time and then of course we
progressed to deeper uh dives into
algorithms and actually implementing
something that's all too real world
these days and implementing electoral
algorithms in a few different forms
dabbling thereafter in a bit of
forensics a bit of imagery and taking
images like this here and filtering it
in a number of ways ultimately
understanding hopefully how these things
are implemented underneath the hood so
that henceforth when all you're doing is
tapping an icon on your phone or
clicking a command on your computer you
can infer even if you didn't write that
particular code how the thing is likely
working and even if you had started to
get your footing then around week four
then things escalated quickly further to
data structures but recall for your
spell checker you implemented a fairly
sophisticated data structure known as a
hash table and even if you struggle to
get that working again think back five
years five weeks prior you were just
trying to get four Loops to work and
variables to work and so if each week
realized there was significant progress
and then if you aggregate all these most
recent weeks with python and SQL HTML
JavaScript and CSS I mean you built your
very own web application and many of you
will go on and build something grander
for your own final project or Focus
again on C or on python alone or the
like but ultimately aggregating all of
these Technologies and kind of stitching
together something that you yourself
created we might have kind of put some
of the foundation there in place but the
the end result ultimately is yours so at
the end of the day as we promised in
week zero this course is really about
computational thinking cleaning up your
thought process getting you to think a
little more logically more methodically
and to express yourself just as
logically and methodically but it's also
about in some form critical thinking and
at the end of the day what computer
science is is really just taking input
producing output ideally correct output
and all the hard stuff is in the middle
there but we do hope you have in your
your toolkit so to speak is all the more
of a mental model all the more of an
understanding of like first principles
from which you can derive new outputs
new conclusions based on those inputs
and certainly today right there's so
much misinformation or miseducation in
the world and just being able to take
input and produce proper output in and
of itself is a compelling skill and
indeed when you all find yourselves
invariably in engineering positions
where you're asked to build something
because you now can or perhaps you're in
a managerial role where you decide you
should build something because you know
people who can I would also start to
consider even though the past 10 plus
weeks have all been about build this
because we asked you to to really start
to consider whether it's for fun for
profession for political purposes or the
like should you build something and
actually considering now that you have
this scale how you can use it most
responsibly and not just make a website
do something or make an app do something
because it can be done but really start
to ask and ask of others like should we
be doing this it's just a skill that you
can but don't necessarily have to use
now when it comes to writing some actual
code keep in mind that you might
continue to evaluate or your employer or
your colleagues might continue to
evaluate your code along these same axes
these are not cs50 specific correctness
does it do does it do what it's supposed
to do design like how well qualitatively
is it implemented and then style how
readable is it how pretty is it and
these three axes should really guide all
of your thinking whether it's for a test
or a project or an open source project
or the like like all three of these
things really matter and so if you're in
the mindset of wondering oh do I have to
worry about style for this do I have to
comment this the answer is always yes
this is what it means to be a good
programmer a good engineer to optimize
these kinds of axes now what about sort
of
two of those tools in the toolkit well
let's focus on just a couple here uh
full circle at the end of the semester
abstraction recall was one of the tools
in the tool kit that we proposed is all
about taking like complicated problems
complicated ideas and simplifying them
to really the essence so you can focus
on really just what matters or what
helps you get real work done and then
related to that was also this notion of
precision even as you abstract things
away you still have to be super precise
when you're writing code for a computer
or just giving instructions to another
human so that they are implementing your
ideas your your algorithms correctly and
sometimes these two goals abstraction
and precision can rather be at odds at
one another and what we thought we'd do
is give everyone a sheet of paper today
which you probably received on the way
in if not a pen as well if you didn't
receive hopefully you or a friend near
you has a sheet of paper and a pen or a
pencil do go ahead and grab that and we
thought we'd uh come full circle too and
see if we can't get a brain volunteer to
come up on the stage here and we just
need someone to give some stage to
directions all right I like it when
people start pointing and pointing how
about you being pointed at yes
yes you yes come on down
will there be one more opportunity after
this come on down what's your name
[Music]
Claire okay a round of applause for
Claire for being so enthusiastic
come on over here would you like to make
a quick introduction to the group yeah
hey
I'm Claire uh yeah that's all you need
to know about me all right so what I'm
about to hand Claire is a sheet of paper
that has a drawing on it and the goal at
hand is for you all to ultimately follow
Claire's hopefully very precise
instructions because she's going to give
you step-by-step instructions and
algorithm if you will for drawing
something on that sheet of paper all
right we're going to keep it in this
vanilla envelope so that folks can't see
through it but this is what we would
like you to give verbal instructions to
the audience to draw and you can say
anything you want but you may not make
physical hand gestures or the like and
or dip it down so everyone can see it
that's so true all right go ahead step
one wait I could say whatever I want
related to this problem yes idea
oh my God give them instructions for
recreating this picture on their paper
okay
start with uh like
like
um a square
but
but it's no hand gestures okay okay
sorry sorry start with a square but it's
like a diamond cut like there's a point
on Top
[Music]
wait I should not be the one doing this
okay so it's like a square but yeah
start with a square
okay step two step two
is that on one of the sides of the
square there's another Square
[Laughter]
doing really well on the abstraction I
don't feel like I'm doing too hot okay
this is does this affect my grade and it
anyway no no
okay two squares okay and then there's
like another Square
but they're like not squares they're
like kind of slanted
um there's another Square in between
like next
next to those squares connecting those
squares okay
any step four
step four is that it should look like a
cube
okay so let's go ahead pause here pause
here let's let's thank Claire for coming
on up bravely I'll take this
if uh let's go ahead and collect just a
few of these if maybe Carter and Valerie
you wouldn't mind helping me grab just a
few sheets of paper if you'd like to
volunteer what it is you drew in those
seconds just hand it over if you would
like no need for a name or anything like
that
okay all right it's very eager thank you
okay thank you
all right
thank you thank you okay
uh sorry okay that's that's plenty let's
come on up if you want to oh you want to
hand me yours too
okay sorry to reach all right so Carter
if you want to meet me up on stage for a
second
so we have a whole bunch of submissions
here
that represent what it was Claire was
describing
let me go ahead and uh just project here
in a moment use my camera so here we
have one let's see Carter piffer to just
bring those on up here
okay so here we have
one I'll hold up
all right so some squares overlapping
started to look more like a cube thank
you so much uh here maybe in more
primitive form
with another one
this one kind of started to have wheels
which was kind of
and then things started to take shape
perhaps at the very end both Big Cube
and small cube what it was that Claire
was showing us now if we project it was
in fact this and it's actually exactly
what Claire you just went through it's
actually a perfect example of like why
abstraction can be hard and where the
line is when you're just trying to
communicate instructions So In fairness
might have been nice to just start with
we're going to draw a cube and like
here's how because that was kind of a
spoiler at the end but that too a cube
is an abstraction but it's not very
precise right like how big is the cube
at what angle is it rotated what is how
are you looking at it and so when you
were struggling to describe these
squares but no they're kind of like
diamonds or whatnot I mean that's
because of this tension between what it
is you're trying to abstract but what it
is you're trying to communicate you
could have gone maybe the complete other
direction and maybe have been super
precise and not abstract this thing in a
way as a cube but say to everyone all
right everyone put your pen down on the
paper now draw a diagonal line to say
Southwest at 45 degrees now do another
one one that's South you could really
get into the weeds and tell people to go
up down left right of course it could
get a little tricky if they sort of
follow the direction incorrectly but it
would be hard for us all to know what it
is we're drawing If all we're hearing
are these very low level instructions
but that's what you're doing when you're
writing code you might Implement a
function called Cube how it works is via
those low level instructions but after
that you just don't care you'd much
rather think about it as a cube function
maybe with some arguments that speak to
the size or the rotation of it or the
like and that's where again abstraction
can come in so as we've discussed for so
many weeks now these trade-offs were
manifest even in week zero even if we
didn't necessarily put our finger on it
just then why don't we do things in a
slightly different direction if we could
get one other volunteer okay come on
down I saw your hand first one other
volunteer who this time we're going to
give the pen to
we're going to give the pen to
and what's your name Jonathan come on up
so I'm going to make this screen be
drawable in just a moment but what we
need you to do first on the honor System
is close your eyes
all right eyes are closed everyone else
in the audience is about to see the
picture that we want you to draw and you
all the audience are going to give
Jonathan the step-by-step instructions
this time around so I stay closed this
is what we're going to want Jonathan to
draw so kind of ingrain it in your mind
if you need a refresher we can have him
close his eyes again but that's what we
want him to draw I'm going to go back to
the blank screen all right Jonathan you
can open your eyes we have a blank
canvas and now step one what would you
like Jonathan to draw first
draw a circle I heard
okay it's a little smaller I'm hearing
now okay you can move it
look no don't do that all right let's
we'll do we'll give you one redo use
three fingers to delete everything
uh three fingers all together
yep there we go
uh farther apart there we go no it's
back
okay I'll do this part yeah okay all
right so I heard thank you I heard draw
a circle would anyone like to finish the
sentence more precisely
a smaller Circle
on top
a medium-sized Circle
at the top all right that's pretty good
medium-sized circle at the top and no
more deleting after this good all right
step two
align straight down
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah okay good all right that was step
two nicely done
what's that step three
draw a line down from the bottom to the
left
[Applause]
at okay
good all right next let's go over here
next one
[Music]
same thing but on the right
yes all right uh that's what one two
three four step five
stay yes step five
[Music]
do that again but higher closer to the
circle
on the right side
[Applause]
oh
are we gonna have to go with it step six
step six
[Music]
starting from the neck draw a line down
into the right
you don't like that he's
what do you want him to do step six
[Music]
can't no one do
where the other line ends say again
we're the other line and
[Music]
near the vertical line
where the other line ends
draw a line that goes down
okay a couple more Steps step seven
seven
draw a horizontally slanting line from
the end of the line you just drew
diagonally
[Music]
okay we're resorting to hand gestures
now but I think that's what you mean yes
okay good or good good all right I have
one or two final steps let's get as
close as we can
[Music]
say hi
make him say hi
no
[Applause]
[Music]
okay hi
okay and maybe one final step we'll give
them one more
say again
[Music]
put one of those lines from high to the
circle
[Music]
a line between High and the circle
all right let's let's show Jonathan
that's pretty darn close let's show him
what what we had in mind was this so a
round of applause for Jonathan too if we
could
a bigger round of applause for Jonathan
if we could
all right so I mean this is actually
there is this thing in in computer
science you know this is pair
programming we're actually programming
with someone else and it's actually not
all that dissimilar trying to
communicate your ideas to someone else
but notice just all of the ambiguities
and it certainly doesn't help that we're
in a big space but all the ambiguities
that arise when you're just trying to
convey something precisely so this is
not necessarily as constrained as a
program would but it's representative of
the end of the day even after all these
weeks this stuff is hard and in fact
it's not necessarily ever going to be
completely straightforward because the
problems you're going to try solving
down the road presumably if you continue
to apply these skills themselves are
just going to get more and more
sophisticated but hopefully the the
feeling you get from accomplishing
something as a result is just going to
rise with them as well before we now do
a bit of review just wanted to offer a
few suggestions and answer to an FAQ
which is like what do I do after a class
like cs50 typically about half of you
will go on and take one or more other
classes in CS which is great building on
this kind of foundation and about half
of you will not like this will be it but
very very likely certainly given how the
world is trending will you have
opportunities in the Arts Humanities
social sciences or Beyond to just apply
programming to data sets to problems in
those own domains and so toward that end
we would encourage you to start thinking
about how you can transition from what
has been your Cloud code space in the
cloud to something client-side like
using your own Mac and PC here on out so
that you're not reliant on a courses
infrastructure a particular website and
even though we used a fairly industry
standard tool you can actually get
almost all of that stuff running with
some effort perhaps on your own Mac and
PC so terminal Windows actually come
built into Mac OS if you go to your util
applications folder utilities there is a
program literally called terminal that
has always been there even if you've
never used it that will behave very
similar to what vs codes does as well in
the World of Windows can you similarly
install a version of the terminal
Windows software that we used in the
Cloud 2 to actually run similar commands
like CD and LS and and much more we
would encourage you ultimately to learn
git you've been indirectly using git
this semester when you run certain
commands we have been using git
underneath the hood of some of cs50s
tools that essentially push your code so
to speak to the cloud to a place like
github.com but git itself is an
incredibly powerful and just useful tool
for one backing up your code somewhere
else to the cloud which is effectively
what we've used it for but to
collaboration so that you can actually
share your code more readily with other
people and three building much bigger
pieces of software where each of you
work on different files different
folders or even just different parts of
the same file and then somehow merge all
of your handiwork together at the end of
the day to build something much bigger
than you as one person could alone vs
code itself now too we've been hosting
it in the cloud a real version of vs
code but it's much more commonly used on
people's own Macs and PCs and you can
download it onto your own Mac and PC you
might have to jump through a few more
Hoops to get things like C working
though python is much easier to get
working as well some of the
configuration won't be quite the same
like your prompt might look a little
different and the like but that's just
going to be the case anytime you sit
down in the future at a different system
it's going to look and feel a little
different to things you've used before
but hopefully there'll be enough
familiarities that you can get yourself
up and running pretty quickly
nonetheless hosting a website not
necessarily something you have to do or
will do for your final project depending
on your proposal but there's lots of
ways to just host your own portfolio
page home page website whatever on the
internet itself using tools like these
GitHub or netlify or other tools too
most of which have like free
student-friendly plans some of these are
indeed paid services but they very often
have entry level plans that are totally
fine if it's just you on the internet
and you don't expect having thousands
ten thousands of users it's a drop in
the bucket for these companies and so
they very often have free tiers of
service if you want to host something
more Dynamic something like cs50 finance
that takes user input and output uses
sessions uses database faces you might
like something like kuroku and for
instance we have some documentation on
one of cs50's websites for actually
moving your implementation of cs50
Finance over to this third-party
application called Heroku so you can
actually run it or something like it in
the cloud as well here too using a free
tier of service all of these providers
these are big cloud providers these days
Amazon Microsoft Google and others all
have student friendly accounts that you
can sign up for during or shortly after
you're in school that just gives you a
free compute time and storage GitHub
itself has this whole student pack that
by transitivity gives you access to a
whole bunch of discounts on other things
as well so if you're liking this stuff
and you just want to like learn more
perhaps over break by playing on your
own these then would be some some good
starting points and as for just keeping
abreast of Trends in programming and
technology or the like there's so many
different blogs and websites out there
but here are just some a couple of
different subreddits so to speak on
Reddit that are very programming
specific stack overflow with which
you've probably probably
interacted server fault which is similar
TechCrunch Y combinator and other sites
too and ultimately we would encourage
all of you to stay in touch certainly
Beyond Today by the time you finish your
final projects we'll have something
waiting for you and if you want to stay
engaged either on the teaching staff or
just as a lifelong learner of Cs and
programming by all means check out any
of these URLs here but in just a few
weeks time will you have one of these to
your name your very own I took cs50
t-shirt which we will distribute before
long
as well and now if we may uh we have an
opportunity here to synthesize the past
several weeks of material if you would
like to go ahead and open up the URL
that we put on the screen earlier I'll
toss it up here again you can use your
phone or your laptop you might recall
for a previous problem set we asked you
to propose a whole bunch of review
questions multiple choice or the like
that synthesize the past several weeks
of material we took some of our favorite
submissions of those ported it to this
poll everywhere platform so that we
could interactively see where everyone's
minds are at understanding is that and I
think you'll find all of these are
written by you and your classmates that
we slipped a few fun ones they are also
written by you along the way of Carter
you want to come on up here to get us
ready if you haven't yet opened the
website go to this URL here on your
phone or your laptop
and let me go ahead and switch this over
here before Carter takes control of this
machine here
's that same 2D barcode again feel free
to background that now and in just a
moment we've got a 20 question quiz show
it's all multiple choice so long as you
have internet access whether you're here
physically or online right now you
should be able to buzz in within 10 to
20 seconds of seeing a question and I'll
read each one aloud I think Carter we're
just about good to go so does everyone
have the software up and running on
their phone or their laptop if not no
big deal just look on with a friend but
otherwise Carter do you want to say
hello to and tee us up absolutely hey
everyone we're going to go ahead and get
started here with our first question
speed here matters so our first question
David go ahead all right what does CSS
stand for it's the first question
written by you four possible options are
cascading style sheet coding style sheet
cascading style system coded style sheet
15 seconds up to 300 responses already
both here in person and online
give folks a few more seconds what does
CSS stand for these are the four options
that were provided three two one Carter
cascading style sheets at 86 percent is
indeed the right answer so congrats to
those of you 86 percent who got that one
here's the leaderboard you all have
fairly random usernames but if your
username is on this board here or really
any of the 86 of you that just got that
right all of you are currently in the
lead but we'll see if this shifts before
long
question two which bests describe the
role of a compiler is our next question
debug one's code run the written program
distinguish between functions and
arguments turn source code into machine
code
300 responses in so far 10 seconds to go
which best describes the role of a
compiler
three seconds just crossed 400 and
Carter
turning source code into machine code at
92 percent some excellent progress there
is indeed the correct answer and indeed
more generally a compiler just converts
one language to another the use cases
we've seen for it have been only source
code to machine code but as you go out
into the real world you'll actually find
there to be compilers from One Source
Code language to another source code
language that itself might be runnable
or compilable thereafter good job to all
of you guests and Carter number three
what is the type of ARG C asks a
classmate int stir Char float
[Music]
what is the type of ARG C
all right about 350 responses seven
seconds to go
about to cross the 400 threshold and
three two one the type of Arc C is
indeed caressed but we're now starting
to distinguish folks only 55 percent
there uh Char is not correct you might
be thinking of ARG V in C but even that
is not a Char it's a Char star array or
a Char star star in fact so it's not
just a Char stir is in Python but even
that too if you were thinking of sys.org
V that would be a list of stirs not a
single stir all right Carter it's the
leaderboard
all right there are guests all and still
tied and number four what is the
searching efficiency of a balanced
binary search tree
Big O of n Big O of N squared Big O of
log n Big O of n log n
what is the searching efficiency of a
balanced binary search tree the balance
being key because as folks continue
buzzing in recall that a cert binary
search trees can de degrade devolve into
linked lists big old Vlog and is correct
for 54 percent
all right now people are getting annoyed
but let's keep going number five
leaderboard's not yet that interesting
more subtle what was the cs50 Ducks
Halloween costume he's here in winter
dress today thanks to Valerie a skeleton
a vampire Frankenstein or a ghost
what was its costume at Halloween a few
weeks back
answers are coming in a little slower
this time
people online or perhaps clicking on the
video
and vampire is correct at 69 nicely done
all right guests are still shuffled in
the top oh and we're starting to see
some leaders pull ahead the time in
which you buzz in is also take into
account now in C how can we unify
several variables of different types
into a single new type
trees arrays strucks tables
[Music]
quiet and see how can we unify several
variables of different types into a
single new type
eight seconds
400 responses in
[Music]
450 and the answer is structs are indeed
correct recall that we had a student
struck and we saw structs later on for
nodes that allowed us to Cluster
multiple variables or data types inside
of our own brand new structure that we
then type def to a name Carter said we
see the leaderboard now
all right whoever guessed 40 45 and 4383
have eeked ahead ever so slightly so
buzzing in fast can now benefit your
score too next question Carter in Python
which of the following statements is
false
tuples are an ordered immutable set of
data dictionaries associate keywords
with values arrays in Python are a fixed
size python is an object-oriented
language which of those statements is
false
[Music]
three seconds answers coming in more
slowly
but the most popular answer is correct
arrays and python are indeed not of a
fixed size which is why that's false
they're not even called arrays they're
called lists and recall that they
dynamically grow and Shrink effectively
implemented for you as a linked list all
right how do we all right we have a
leader whoever 4383 is nicely done
what does stir comp return in C
it's trcmp does it return a Boolean an
integer a string or a char
[Music]
what does stir comp return in C used to
compare two strings of course
recall that it returns
potentially not just true false but ooh
an integer is indeed correct does anyone
Recall why why is it an INT and not just
a simple true false
why is there are three values helpful
exactly it returns zero if they're equal
or returns negative value or a positive
value based on whether one string comes
before or after the other asciabatically
so to speak based on its ASCII code uh
the results Carter all right 4383 still
doing quite well but
being caught up with here what is David
malin's phone number
949-468-2750 play when you call it
the Harvard alma mater a parody of Yale
song a recording of David Malin singing
Never Gonna Give You Up
feel free to call or text I can't get it
now but we have nicely automated that
process
four seconds 400 responses in and the
answer of course is Never Gonna Give You
Up thanks to a little programming and a
script that our friend Rong Shin wrote
that essentially answers the phone
automatically and replies with a URL or
a song Carter
[Music]
oh
Dethrone Dethrone 2688 nicely done next
question
from which of the following places does
malloc get free memory for a program to
use
keep stack array or pointer
from which of the following places does
malloc get free memory for a program to
use
[Music]
answers are a little slower this time
five seconds
[Music]
and the answer is in
okay that's the answer we were given in
the problem set but I think uh we would
beg to differ pretty sure Carter would
you go with I would go with the Heap I
think it's indeed the Heap so this
answer not correct
I know I know we just transcribed what
you gave us though let's see how that
affects the scores
okay 2688 is still doing okay next
question about 10 or so to go suppose I
have an unsorted list of items store
receipts perhaps should I sort the items
before searching for an element
yes you should always sort before
searching no you should never sort
before searching if you will be
searching the list many times then yes
you should sort first if you will be
searching the list many times then no
you should not sort first
some nuanced replies five seconds
a few fewer answers than usual at this
point and if you will be searching the
list many times then yes you should
short first an example that we discussed
of trade-offs because if you're just
going to do a one-off search and never
again why bother incurring n log n or n
Square time to actually sort the thing
all right some shuffling happening but
2688 nicely done next question
when you run the create index command in
SQL what type of data structure do you
create array B trees linked lists hash
tables
when you run create index recall we did
this with like the movie titles the TV
show titles to speed things up so that
things wouldn't be super long and linear
we did a different data structure
all right about 400 responses in the
answer
is indeed bee trees bee trees not to be
confused with binary tree a Bee Tree
typically has other children besides two
that pulls the data even higher up from
the leaves of the tree could use a hash
table could use a linked list but indeed
the technology and databases is
generally these things called B tree
certainly in SQL light Carter
oh Dethrone but 4179 has now pulled
ahead nicely done next question
what HTTP status code means I'm a teapot
zero zero zero four one eight zero zero
seven one two eight
this recall was a April Fool's joke by
technical people uh some years ago that
has become part of computing lore
it's still there though in the document
in two seconds we'll know that it's 4 18
indeed let's see how that affected
things
four one seven nine is way down on the
list 7280 is number one now
nicely done what is an example of a SQL
injection attack when someone submits
malicious SQL commands via web form
physically destroying a computer
hardware that stores a SQL database
overwhelming a server with thousands of
requests to access a database injection
attacks are only in movies or TV
five seconds some fun answers
400 responses about in and indeed when
someone submits malicious SQL commands
via a web form because the you the
programmer is not escaping the code
using the question mark syntax that
we've seen using cs50s library or other
third-party libraries like it Carter
7280 is still the guest to beat nearing
the end few more questions how are the
elements of an array stored in memory
contiguously in random locations that
happen to be available as a linked list
as a binary tree
how are the elements of an array stored
in memory
[Music]
about five seconds to go almost have
everyone in
two
one and contiguously is indeed the right
answer back to back to back in random
locations that happen to be available
he's probably describing your use of
malloc in the Heap but you would then
need a linked list or some other
structure to stitch those locations
together in Array by definition is
contiguous Carter
7280 is hanging on to that lead by about
uh 499 points next up is which SQL query
would allow you to select the ID of a
specific movie star Zendaya in a table
of movie stars
select ID where name equals Zendaya
select star ID for movie stars where
name equals and Daya select ID from
movie stars where name equals Zendaya
select ID for movie stars where name
equals quote unquote Zendaya
and I I'm spoiling it uh I should have
read out some quotes earlier too one
second
the last one is correct and indeed this
one's almost correct but lacks the
single quotes Zendaya is not a single uh
it's not a SQL key word it's of course a
string so it does need to be escaped
there but 63 of you realize that 7280 is
still in the lead I think we have a few
more questions to go
why is a hash table faster to search
than a linked list even though the run
time for both is Big O of n
the hash table actually has a big O of N
squared run time the hash table
optimally has Omega of O's run time the
hash table creates shorter linked lists
to search rather than one long linked
list the hash table takes less memory
and this was an example of practical
versus theoretical differences
and indeed that was interesting with 83
percent of you buzzing in the hash table
creates shorter linked lists ideally if
you have a good hash function rather
than one long linked list even though
technically it's still in Big O of n
7280 seem to know that is pulling ahead
of the crowd still a few questions is
Game of Thrones is a dot dot dot comedy
drama historical fantasy documentary
romance sci-fi or all of the above
this is written by your classmates
recall based on
our SQL week
in five seconds
we'll be reminded that according to our
CSV file they were all of the okay all
of the above
all right 7280 did okay with that next
question which of the following is a
golden rule when allocating memory
every block of memory that you malloc
must be freed only memory that you
malloc should be freed Do Not Free a
block of memory more than once all of
the above
more into the nuances of C this Golden
Rule when allocating memory didn't have
to worry about this in Python we did in
C in two seconds we'll know that all of
the above are indeed things you must do
not doing those would be in fact bugs
Carter the leaderboard
still doing well 7280 whoever you are
last few questions last question in fact
last question what do the binary bulbs
on stage spell today the answers could
be
uh faced with medical mask faced with
tears of joy snowman without snow or Red
Heart
what do the binary bulbs on stage spell
six five four three
[Music]
the answer is the red heart taking a
look at the leaderboard here who's our
winner
[Music]
the winner is hello guess 34.87 a big
round of applause for our guest thank
you to Carter
so it's it's nice that there's some
opportunity here
um because recall that in week zero we
did start talking about emoji and really
about data and representation and we
talked not about just binary but ASCII
and then Unicode and then when we had
Unicode we had all of these additional
bits that we could play with and we
could start to represent not just
letters of the English alphabet as in
ASCII but really letters of any human
alphabet and even alphabets that are
continuing to develop and indeed this
was faced with medical masks which we
claimed at the time was just how a Mac
or PC or Android phone or iPhone
nowadays would interpret and display a
pattern of bits like this this happening
to be for the four bytes that represent
that particular emoji and over time
humans have been deciding to use
different patterns for new and uh new
emojis that might not have existed
yesterday and indeed most anytime you
update your Mac or your PC or your phone
these days at least on a semi-annual
basis are you getting some new and
improved emojis and they're not just
these faces now they're of course
representing different human emotions
different physical objects and
ultimately among the Unicode
consortium's goals is to be able to
represent all human languages but were
it not for certain groups of people and
certain individuals these things would
all rather look fairly similar and
indeed today we're so pleased to be
joined by an old classmate of mine
Jennifer a Lee who was class of 99 here
at the college who's gone off to do many
many different things in life
prolifically so not only has she been a
writer an author a journalist for the
New York Times a producer of films like
the Harvard computers the search for
General Tso and the Emoji story which
focuses on exactly today's topic Jenny
and her colleagues have been involved
particularly with um championing
representation of different types of
people and cultures and languages and
these are just a few of the emojis that
our friend Jenny has indeed brought into
creation on our phones and laptops Jenny
2 is the original inspiration for what
has become it seems my Twitter
recommendations and all of these puppets
I was visiting her in Manhattan one time
some years ago she had on her shelf a
couple of Puppets known as Muppet
whatnots at the time you could go to FAO
Schwartz or the website therefore an Old
Toad store and you could actually
configure your very own Muppets and I
thought this was the coolest thing and
literally on the cab ride home from her
place was I logging into the website
configuring a couple of Puppets a couple
weeks later they arrived and then rather
sat on my shelf for a couple of years as
I wondered why I had just bought two
Muppets in the back of a cab but brought
them into the office at one point a
colleague saw them Drew inspiration from
them and now have they been woven really
into the fabric of this course in
particular and a lot of the courses
pedagogy at least incarnated here just
for fun but also in video form as well
which is only to say so glad that our
friend Jenny ately is here for us us
today to talk about these Emoji Jenny
all right
well this is very exciting I took cs50
in 1994
um to give you a sense one of my block
mates was the first intern for Netscape
if you guys have ever heard of Netscape
and I graduated just as Google was come
like we did not have Google when we were
undergrads so
um it's a honor obviously to be in um at
cs50 it's also very impressive to see
how David has turned it from uh
entry-level computer science course into
a Lifestyle brand that is world renowned
so it's an honor and I'm going to talk
to you today about how an emoji becomes
an emoji
um so first I'm going to talk about my
journey down the rabbit hole of how I
got involved with Emoji so this is my
friend Ian Liu she is a designer famous
for Designing the Twitter fail well
which was like this kind of image that
puffed up
when Twitter went down which back in the
day was rather often so she's Chinese
Australian American so which is like a
weird interesting combination and so one
day we were texting about dumplings
because that is what chinese-ish women
do we talked about food and so I sent
her this picture of dumplings and then
she said yum yum yum yum yum
um you know knife and forth knife and
fork knife and fork and then she was
like oh I'm surprised that Apple doesn't
have a dumpling emoji and I'm like oh
yeah that's kind of weird and you know
it's one of those things where
you know the thought comes to your head
and then it leaves I I was you know
which is sort of an observation but then
half an hour later on to my phone pops
up this like dumpling Emoji with hearts
actually you can't see it here but it
actually had like blinking eyes so she
called it bling bling dumpling
she's a designer so she decided she was
gonna fix
um this like lack of dumpling Emoji
problem and I was actually like really
puzzled like how could there be no
dumpling Emoji right
because you know I knew that emoji
originally Japanese this by the way was
back in 2015. So Japanese Foods super
well represented on the Emoji Keyboard
yo Brahman you have tempura you have
Curry you have actually Bento Box Curry
then tempura you have you even have like
kind of slightly weird foods like
um
let's see you had these like
things on a stick which are fish cakes I
discovered then you have this white and
pink swirly thing which is also a fish
cake you even have this like triangle
thing that looks like it's had a bikini
wax but in essence there were all these
foods that were on the keyboard but
there was no dumpling right
and I was like dumplings are this kind
of universal food like every culture has
some version of a dumpling whether or
not it's empanadas or ravioli or
um God what else ravioli pierogi Momos
you know the whole idea is all cultures
have basically found the idea like this
concept of like yummy goodness within a
carbohydrate shell whether or not it's
baked or steamed or fried so dumplings
are Universal Emoji I didn't use them
that much but I was like they're also
kind of universal so the fact there was
no dumpling Emoji tell me like whatever
system
was in place failed and I actually had
no idea I was like who controls Emoji
I'm going to go fix this problem like
there's something wrong with the
universe if there's no dumpling emoji
and I took it upon myself to like go fix
that so I Googled
um and I basically discovered there was
this thing you know called the Unicode
Consortium which is a non-profit based
in count uh let's see Mountain View
California that when I looked had these
like 12 full voting members so this is
late 2015.
of those 12 nine were
multinational U.S tech companies so
there's Oracle IBM Microsoft Adobe
Google Apple Facebook and Yahoo so these
were
um eight I think and then
you had the German software company sap
the Chinese company called Huawei and
then the government of Oman so these
were like basically the people who were
in charge and had full voting power on
unicode
so they paid eighteen thousand dollars a
year
um to have this full voting power which
is a lot of money I was like kind of
very indignant on like how this cabal of
tech companies basically control This
Global
um curated image based language on your
keyboard so there was a little bit of a
kind of loophole which is you could you
could pay 18 000 a year to have full
voting power or
um you can pay 75 a year as an
individual you had no voting power but
you had the ability
to sign up for the email list and also
show up at the meetings so put in my
credit card got an email list
and
like
was like kind of checking my email one
day when there was an invite that said
they were going to have a quarterly
meeting and I think this was going to be
October 2015.
and I looked it was in Sunnyvale I
looked at my calendar I looked at you
know the point that I was actually going
to be able to be in Silicon Valley at
that time so I took a bus to Apple where
they were having that meeting and I
don't know completely what I thought I
was going to see like I think maybe it
was going to be like maybe like a
Sanders Theater or like a little mini
Congress like people making Emoji
decisions but that was not what it was
basically this is the room where it
happens these in 2015 where the people
who were deciding Emoji you know these
were Emoji decision makers which were
not like the most demographically kind
of um diverse group they had a sense of
humor about it one guy had a shirt that
said shadowy Emoji Overlord
and so I decided along with my friend
Ian Liu to create a group called
EmojiNation whose motto is Emoji by the
people for the people and it kind of
kind of brought the voice of like the
normal world into the decision-making
chain
so
um you know we launched a little
campaign about dumpling emojis we made a
Kickstarter video
um let's see dumplings are one of the
most universal cross-cultural Foods in
the world Georgia has kinkali Japan has
gyoza Korea has Mandu Italy has ravioli
Poland has pierogi Russia has pal many
Argentina has empanadas Jewish people
have krep left China has pot stickers
Nepal and Tibet have Momos yet somehow
despite their popularity there is no
dumpling Emoji in the standard set why
is that emoji exists for pizza tempura
Sushi spaghetti hot dog and now tacos
which Taco Bell takes credit for we need
to write this disparity dumplings are
Global Emoji are Global isn't it time we
brought them together
oh yeah oh well we're at it how about an
emoji for Chinese takeout
[Music]
um
this is
giving a 2015 I wrote a dumpling Emoji
proposal this is it
um you know kind of different styles
like whether or not it's a head-on view
or a slightly diagonal view
um and so we we that's Yi Ying with then
um one of the co-chairs of the Emoji
subcommittee
and so along with dumpling we also did
take out box we got Chopsticks and then
fortune cookie which actually I have to
be honest I don't think fortune cookie
would have gotten in on its own merits
were not on the quote tales of the other
three so we got these four through
um and you know that that is how they
look today and I have to say that that
dumpling looks really photo realistic in
the Apple World unlike
the fortune cookie which has like no it
looks like a dead Pac-Man I don't know
what is going on with that
um design but uh so very proud you know
I also did a lot of research on Chinese
food in America and wrote a book called
the fortune cookie Chronicles produced a
documentary called the search for
General so so like I had a lot of moral
Authority on the issues of uh you know
Asian food in America not all things but
this one I felt like I had like made a
mark on the 2500 year history of emoji
oh sorry of uh dumplings I'm moving them
into emoji so it kind of gets in this
very complicated thing like how does an
emoji become an emoji and it's actually
fairly complex
um so let's say you have an idea for an
emoji you write a proposal
and then you submit it to the Emoji
subcommittee
um that line like debates and thinks
about it sometimes they have feedback
and they kick it back to you and if so
then you have to revise it and it kind
of goes around around in a circle and
and then they once they're happy with it
they kick it to the full Unicode
technical committee which is sort of
like a sort of a governing body within
Unicode on things Technical and encoding
so what are the kinds of things that
impact
um whether an emoji can be an emoji so
one is there popular demand is it
frequently requested
um
and at this point one of the very crude
ways that we measure is if you search
for it on Google does it have more than
500 million uh kind of like results
which is what elephant gets in English
and that's sort of like a median Like
Elephant is like kind of right in the
middle of like popular emoji and not
popular emojis so we use that as a
benchmark
there's a plus if there's multiple
usages and meanings for example
um
like sloth
that was an emoji that we did it also
you know it's both in it literally kind
of an emoji of an animal but it also has
lots of connotations so something has
lots of multiple meanings that kind of
gives it a bum
um one thing is visually distinctive
like does it work at little tiny Emoji
sizes and that's actually really hard
because there's some things that I think
could have been Emoji but don't
completely work when you try to shrink
it down and I'll give some examples of
that later and then
kind of filling the gap or completeness
is another Factor so for a long time we
had Red Heart yellow heart green heart
blue heart Purple Heart there was no
orange heart and so there was
um a gay designer from Adobe who was
like actually very heartbroken by that
so he had been substituting the pumpkin
to get the orange to get the rainbow and
so he proposed an orange heart and that
was you know obviously at that point
you're like yes that will complete a set
and another thing is is it already
something that you know one of the
companies
um has and therefore everyone else
is going to like adopt it and so a good
example for that is
um the binary I think it was a
non-gender binary Emoji the pink blue
and white flag so I have to say WhatsApp
is by far one of the most Rogue
um platforms so they just like randomly
like added it one day and we just
noticed it and we're like oh God given
that they have to do it now we have to
build it into the Stop
um so factors of exclusion
were against inclusion to be more PC
sometimes if it's too specific or narrow
um that works against being included so
poutine which the Canadians love is kind
of really specific and I know it's
really important to the Canadians but it
just kind of didn't have enough sort of
global appeal if it's redundant so an
example for that is a couple years ago
Butterball proposed like a roasted
turkey Emoji but we already had like an
unroasted live emoji of a turkey so it
wasn't clear that we needed the cooked
version to go with like the live version
so that didn't pass
um not visually discernible so this
one's actually really tricky
um and knocks out a lot of things so it
knocked out kimchi for example really
hard to do kimchi had Emoji sizes like
how you is it in the jar is it like you
know just sort of in a little bowl so
kimchi kind of got kind of died on that
another one that was really hard was
cave Emoji actually really hard out of
exercises and then this is interesting
no logos Brands deities or celebrities
and this is a new policy we just
introduced which is no more flags flags
were killing us in terms of all kinds of
complicated reasons and there was much
regret that we ever added flags and
um and and lots of politics so at this
point we're no more Flags
so once it kind of gets passed into the
the full Unicode technical committee The
Proposal gets voted on like once a year
and then they pass all the emoji for the
next year we just actually did that a
couple weeks ago and it takes a while it
gets sent to all the companies like
apple Google Adobe Facebook and then
they add it to all your devices and
and then ta-da it takes about 18 to 24
months from when you have first have
your proposal
to when it lands onto your devices so
EmojiNation has worked on a bunch of
emoji and so we've kind of shepherded us
through so one of the interesting
questions is why isn't that Unicode
controls Emoji so a lot of it has to go
um kind of do what has to do with the
history of emoji they were originally
popularized in Japan there was a very
one of the initial sets is from 1999
from docomo these were actually recently
collected by the Museum of Modern Art in
New York City
um and so all the the Japanese
um vendors had these like little glyphs
that they added to their character set
and the main problem is like if you were
docomo you had like you know one stat if
you were in SoftBank you had another set
so no matter what you couldn't you could
only kind of text the people who are on
your platform not across platforms and
that was a real big problem when Apple
and Google started introducing
smartphones into
Japan and there was sort of this kind of
understanding and expectation that if
you if you did something in your
smartphone you also want it to show up
an email and be sent into you know Into
The Ether and someone else is supposed
to get the same uh image that you sent
so that was not the case so in 2007 they
went to Unicode and asked them to like
basically unify the Emoji set and
unicode is interesting because its
mission is to enable everyone
uh speaking every language on Earth to
be able to use their language on
computers and smartphones and they
actually see this as a human right
because at a certain point if your
language cannot be captured digitally
it's going to disappear so you know they
spend a lot of time doing Chinese Arabic
uh Cyrillic in the very early days
in 2001 they actually had a proposal for
Klingon which they did not actually
accept at that point so they have three
major projects they encode characters
including Emoji that's actually what
they're most famous for they also have a
bunch of localization resources so
um that's like you know in this country
they use this as a currency and they use
this kind of
um time format and like it's you know
whether or not it's month month date
date year year in some countries it's
you know date date month month year
you're in other countries so they kind
of tell you what country cares about
what and then they also then have the
libraries
um so that no one's basically
programming things from scratch
so what's really funny is you say cldr
really fast it sounds like seal deer and
this really confused one of the
girlfriends one of the engineers why he
was always talking about sealed ears and
so she uh basically surgically attached
a bunch of antlers to this little guy
um and made a sealed deer and so it took
three years between 2007 to 2010 to
introduce the first Unicode Emoji set so
this these were the ones that kind of
came out it took many many years to
figure out like how to reconcile all the
different images and like which one
should we include which ones we
shouldn't include
um and as you guys probably know from
cs50 a Unicode code point is a unique
number assigned to each Unicode
character
so you can represent that emoji tears
with face of tears of joy as this or
this or the binary code
so Emoji are just kind of hanging out on
your phone
after 2010 until 2011 when Apple
suddenly made them much easier to access
on your phone and one of the kind of
confusing things of course is like Emoji
are very ambiguous and it's not always
clear what they mean and that's one of
the great Joys right it's it can be more
um there's there's much more
interpretation on on on in terms between
the sender and the receiver so if you
actually look if you start doing that on
Google the the autocompletes are like
what does it mean when a guy sends it to
you what does it mean when the girl
sends it to you and
um clearly many many people have been
confused by that emoji when it's been
sent to them so who can propose emoji
and the short answer is basically anyone
uh there's a Google form that is open
between April and August
um City hijab Emoji actually was
originally proposed by a 15 year old
girl who is Saudi Arabian but lived in
Germany
who actually got into Harvard and then
chose Stanford so I've always giving her
a hard time about that I know
on that I was
I was um
she wrote the proposal it's and it
through and she's actually the subject
of the documentary that we put together
called the Emoji story we also have a
group of argentinians who fought really
hard for the mate Emoji their national
drink and then there was this non-profit
for girls advocacy that really wanted a
menstruation emoji and they sent in this
bloody Underpants proposal which is like
really terrible I'll be honest so we
kind of worked with them and got blood
drop which actually is one of like
actually has done pretty statistically
like like well we were kind of surprised
actually how popular it is
um the skin tone Emoji were actually
proposed not from within Unicode clearly
it was done by a mom from Houston who's
also an entrepreneur because her
daughter asked her came home one day and
said
um
I'd really like an emoji that looks like
me and her mom Katrina Parrott was like
that's great honey what's an emoji and
so but she actually had worked in
procurement with NASA and so she
understood foreign from proposals and
she actually was the one we should thank
for having like five skin tones today
um women's flat shoe and sort of the
one-piece bathing suit and as opposed to
just the you know uh yellow you know
teeny weeny yellow polka dot bikini is a
mother of three now four who
um just wrote that because she was very
offended that all of the shoe Emoji had
high heels for women
um I actually really like this guy some
random guy in Germany came up with this
uh Emoji as we like to say it's a kobear
Emoji he wrote a proposal and got
accepted because it was a really good
proposal then you even have governments
The Finnish government
like literally to finish government
their equivalent of the Department of
State uh proposed a sauna Emoji which
these are the images and I think they're
really ugly for I mean they're all
there's there's so many problems with
this Emoji but we helped them as Emoji
Nation first we like got rid of the club
feet and then you know gave them you
know sort of examples like you know do
you want them to hold the ladle do you
want like the the sort of steam around
it do you want like it um
you know with like
clothing or not clothing we actually did
um a little you know a little bit of a
towel for the more modest in us so it
got passed and then the way it ended up
is basically person in a steamy room so
this is how it kind of evolved so you
can see that is what Finland kind of
submitted that is what we submitted and
then that is how it's ended up on your
phone and that is basically supposed to
mean sauna Emoji
um so one of the questions is like why
do I care so much about emoji and
representation of emoji and a lot of it
has to do with the fact that I grew up
speaking Chinese and like going to
Sunday school or Saturday
um Chinese School
and
and as you can see there's sort of like
some really interesting parallels
between modern day emoji and like
Chinese radicals and characters from a
long time ago so this is fire this is
mouth this is tree this is moon this is
Sun uh you can mix and match them in
Chinese as well so one of the
interesting ones is like you know two
trees together
basically makes a forest you have like a
sun and a moon together and that means
bright in Chinese
it's kind of fun then
um this one's fun right so it's
basically a pig underneath
a roof
so you're like oh maybe that means Farm
or like I don't know like a barn or some
kind of like animal thing but actually
that in Chinese means home ja or family
so like whom is where your pigs are
which I think is says a lot about
society and what people cared about way
back in ancient China
um
this is one of my favorites so this is a
character for woman or female me and I
guess it kind of looks like this like
you know she's like curtsying or
something so
um super interesting character if you
like grow up
like you know writing your characters
you know so
um so this is a woman underneath a roof
and you're like oh that might mean like
wife or family or something but um it
actually doesn't it means peace on so
the idea is like things are at peace
when the woman is under a roof which I
always thought kind of like I felt like
kind of weird about that growing up
um another one is okay there's a woman
and then you have a child or Boy Child
specifically
so you're like oh that might mean family
or mother or something but actually it
means good so the standard for good in
ancient China was a woman with a Boy
Child which I thought was also you know
as a six-year-old was I found
problematic as well
um and all kinds of interesting things
in Chinese use the female radical so
three women together means evil this one
means greedy this one means slave
this one means jealous
this one means betrayal or adultery
which I think is interesting
so in case you want to bring this to
your favorite 10 year old we have a
Chinese like an emoji uh kids book
coming out from MIT press in the fall
called Han Moji from so it's from MIT
teen press it's super fun so it's a lot
of these Concepts so like a little bit
more rigorous and
um this idea of
like gender in emoji was really
important to a bunch of us as we were
kind of working through the issues so
for a long time you know on the Emoji
Keyboard there are all kinds of jobs you
could have as a man like you could be a
police officer you could be a detective
you could be a Buckingham Palace guard
you could even be Sienna you could be
Black Santa right but until as of 2015
if you're a woman there are only four
jobs you could have on the emoji
keyboard so you could be a princess you
could be a bride you'd be a dancer or
you could believe bunny so those are
your like four choices and
um so we worked really hard on like
trying to diversify what women could be
and one of the ways we did it was
through this idea of like combining
Emoji so in Emoji Land there's something
called zwidge a zero witch Joiner and a
lot of emoji you see are actually glued
together
so the rainbow plus flag is how you get
rainbow flag and this is actually how
we've worked on introducing a bunch of
the
um the occupations in Emoji Land so a
lot of these are like you know the chef
is a woman plus
um like the Fry frying pan or a teacher
is a woman Plus or a man actually plus a
school
um and
so one of the interesting things is you
can actually have
um
as a result of all the gender parity
stuff we actually had to make male and
female versions of all the Emoji because
some of them originally were passed as
like man and tuxedo and now because we
had gendered versions of everything we
now have women with tuxedo I don't know
if you noticed there's also a man in a
wedding dress to to kind of compliment
the woman in a wedding dress
um there's now actually also bearded
woman I don't know if you've noticed
that
so it gets interesting because
originally I was from we had passed
women breastfeeding and then there was
like all this like complaints coming
into Unicode about what about men as
caretakers you can't actually tell she's
breastfeeding it's more just like she's
holding it so people were like what
about the man As a caretaker like
fraternity leave and so
um there was now like like man kind of
nursing the child and
um
the other kind of ways you can combine
the Emoji are through skin tones so
unfortunately those are not through his
ridges this is sort of older kind of
Technology where you have all the skin
tones are basically the yellow character
plus like a little square box at the end
we call them skin tone modifiers and
um in terms of what are the things that
we worked on at EmojiNation which is one
of the hardest ones was to create
the interracial couples and we worked on
that with Tinder which really cared
about it because apparently which I
thought was interesting when you
introduce online dating into a community
the rates of interracial marriage go up
and there's a pretty interesting
academic favor that kind of
systematically looks at the rollout
through different countries and
different communities
so it was really nice to see it
introduced on the phone one of my
friends cried
um in terms of EmojiNation Emoji we've
worked on a lot so these are just a
sampling of the ones that we've
um done I really liked let's see
DNA I feel really good about Lobster on
behalf of people from Maine
yarn and thread for all the people who
like knitting there was Bagel emoji on
behalf of like all New Yorkers
this Emoji actually which we called
microbe was like very sleepy on the
keyboard until 2020 and it really had
its moment I really really kind of proud
proud of that one and
um
there is Yoga Emoji sponge so these are
just a sampling of the ones that we
worked on and this is a sampling of the
people who have contributed you too if
you feel really passionate about Emoji
could like impact billions of keyboards
worldwide
so it's interesting to see in terms of
frequency of use it's very power law
right so here sort of these are actually
um
like order magnitude like so one is half
of this two is half of one all the way
down and one of the most stunning things
I I was surprised to see is that face of
tears are Joy by itself is like almost
10 of all Emoji scent 9.9 of emoji is
just that one character number two is
red heart which I guess you guys can see
in its binary form and then it falls off
like pretty quickly so I know I'm
hearing that face of tears are Joy is
very Boomer or very Gen X and that it's
uh maybe among you guys it's a little
bit kind of um
blase or de Clase at this point
um so the future Emoji we really don't
Unico does not want to be encoding Emoji
um and along the way I became a vice
chair of the Unicode Emoji subcommittee
so I went from like kind of shaking my
my fists at the institution to becoming
part of the institution
um so there's one idea this coded hash
of arbitrary images can we create a
system where instead of
um just using a binary code to represent
a different Emoji we actually can
do specific images we create hashes and
then like you look and you can look up
like by the hash which image you're
looking you know at so that was the idea
this is from a standard Professor didn't
really get take off then there was this
idea using Wikipedia
um or Wikimedia the wikidata qid numbers
which I didn't know this until this
proposal came along but everything in
Wikipedia has a number
and that allows it to sort of match
things between different languages so in
Chinese the page for Obama match is
matched with the English page with this
you know Arabic page and that went
nowhere so
um what I'm going to finish with is
telling you what the new Emoji are you
guys are among the first people to hear
about this because no one's really
paying attention so this probably this
was published a couple weeks ago but
like like it made no news because you
have to be looking at the Unicode
register
um so first off more Hearts because you
guys all love heart so there's light
blue heart gray heart and pink heart
there was kind of debate do we need more
pink hearts the answer seems to be yes
um light blue is really interesting
because In some cultures light blue and
dark blue are different colors in our
culture we just call them like versions
of blue it's sort of like how in r in
English pink and red are different
colors but
um In some cultures there isn't a
difference between pink and red
then there are a bunch of bird things
the wing Emoji is coming Blackbird and
Goose I don't really don't really know
why
um High incense uh as a flower this has
like very popular and Iranian culture
jellyfish I don't know I I
I'm very suspicious of jellyfish because
um they used to they used Mana War as
one of their like phrases that they
searched for and that had a billion I
think like it had a lot of entries and I
feel like those were not about the
actual invertebrate like there was
something else going on there but kind
of wrote in on that
um moose on behalf of the Canadians
donkey on behalf of I guess the
Democrats
um so that was interesting because like
you had to have the donkey look
different from a horse and there was a
whole debate like do you want a donkey
head or do you want a donkey body do you
want donkey with fluffy ears do you want
like all kinds of donkey debate and it
was actually originally proposed in 2019
and just got in this year
um Ginger uh and Peapod these are these
are kind of weird like the food things
kind of got in in a weird way Ginger was
good because it also represented root
and then Wireless got in which is
interesting because we couldn't use the
phrase Wi-Fi because that's actually
trademarked by like the wi-fi people and
then on behalf of um seeks conda finally
got it it was the largest religion that
wasn't already represented on the emoji
keyboard and then on behalf of like the
faces shaking phase so
I don't I'm glad you guys are really
excited by that it is it is unclear to
me
um like I was not a big proponent of
this but your excitement about it makes
me change my mind
um then holding hand fan I actually find
that one interesting because I think it
was just like college students were
fresh out of college students who are
like we want to do a proposal that
passes and they were very opportunistic
and just sort of like chose fan and then
first they submitted electric fan and
then we
tell them like oh the longevity for
electric fan isn't great even though
it's been around for a couple hundred
years why don't we go with the folding
hand fan which is a much longer history
and then this one is actually a big deal
is um afro hair pick on behalf there's a
lot of controversy about debate about
curly hair and it's supposed to be
represent afros and then Apple did not
do that so everyone else was very
afro-looking hair Apple just makes it
look wavy and so there was like
upsetness that like black hair wasn't
represented in emoji set and so this was
a proposal that someone worked on
um and then animals uh sorry not animals
instruments Maracas and flute
um and that's a so in terms of if you
have any questions you can look at
emojination.org you can email me for all
things Emoji
um Jenny at emotionation.org and
remember you guys can actually impact
billions of keyboards around the world I
mean it's a little bit of impact for
humans but billions so it adds up to a
lot and if you have any more questions I
am here and can give you know lots of
answers and questions and I'm really
thrilled actually to kind of bring the
Emoji
um flag waving to such a large crowd and
especially a large you know diverse and
very motivated crowd and
um one of the interesting things is
we've kind of like
this is I'm not a profound of this but
they slowly decrease the number of emoji
per year it was like 70 then it was 50
then it was 30 and this year we only did
20 and I'm
um I'm a little bit sad about that but I
hope that you know if there's more you
know excited
um proposals that can be submitted to
Unicode we might be able to dial that
number back up so
that is me am I good yay so thank you
[Applause]
we'll think this is about 20 years late
but thank you so much Jenny we have in I
took cs50 t-shirt for you
on the way out too we have some cs50
stress balls for you cannot wait to see
your final projects coming up if you'd
like to chat with Jenny this was cs50
see you soon
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right this is cs50 and this is first
year family weekend here at Harvard so
welcome to all the moms and dads
brothers sisters cousins Aunts Uncles
grandparents and Beyond cs50 here is
Harvard University's introduction to the
intellectual Enterprises of computer
science and the Art of programming and
what that means is that what we've been
doing in here over the past several
weeks is introducing students to
computational thinking the process of
cleaning up one's thoughts and
expressing oneself all the more
correctly all the more precisely and
ultimately translating those thoughts of
course to a computer in the form of
programming which is where we've spent
quite a bit of time programming writing
code over the past several weeks but
toward that end we've also been
equipping students with some basic
building blocks you might already know
if a parent a that computers only
somehow speak zeros and ones even if
you're not necessarily a computer person
yourself or know what that means but
with those zeros and ones can we
represent numbers and letters and colors
and videos and more and in fact fact
your your child perhaps sitting next to
you could perhaps tell you what today's
message says here we have 64 light bulbs
on stage and if you look at eight of
them at a time there's a pattern of
bulbs that are either on or off that if
you know the code so to speak can you
actually convert these bits these zeros
and ones in light bulb form to today's
particular message now before we begin
we thought we'd make this as engaging as
interactive as possible rather than
focus on any assumptions of Prior
Computing knowledge you need to know
nothing today other than how to operate
for instance your own phone or a laptop
or desktop or the like and indeed we'll
assume a general audience and in this
Halloween week what we also see if we
can't scare you a little bit into
practicing better practices when it
comes specifically to the security or
cyber security of the device you carry
with you every day in your pocket use on
your desk on your laptop or Beyond so if
you haven't already whether you're here
in person or tuning in online go to this
URL here which will lead you to an
interactive polling tool any phone or
laptop or desktop suffices if it's a
little easier than typing in this URL
you can just scan this code with your
phone's camera
take a moment to just open your camera
and hopefully if you're at a good enough
angle and we've made this thing big
enough this is a two-dimensional barcode
or QR code embedded in which is that
exact same URL we're increasingly seeing
this throughout the world as a mechanism
for doing what many of you are doing
right now linking the physical world to
the virtual but that URL again is simply
this one here and in a moment you'll see
on your screen it's okay if you weren't
quite able to get that working feel free
to glance to the left or to the right of
you for someone else who did let me go
ahead and full screen a question just to
ask of everyone here as we focus today
on cyber security
is your phone secure
whether an Android phone an iPhone or
anything else if you're holding it in
your hand right now here in person or
online you should see three possible
answers yes or no or unsure we've got
over 300 responses come in already in a
moment I'll flip over and reveal the
results and see if we can't see how much
work we have to do together here today A
few more seconds almost up to 400
answers
almost up to 400 it's okay if those keep
coming in I'm going to toggle back and
show the results in just a moment here
and the results are now in according to
a response rate of over 400 it looks
like 36 percent of you don't need what
we're about to do here today which is
great we'll see if we can't poke some
holes though and maybe some assumptions
you all are making 31 32 percent maybe
of you are a little are saying no your
phone is not secure so so glad you came
and then understandably to another third
of you are unsure so in very good
company today and we'll see if we can't
open the eyes of everyone in each of
these disparate audiences well let's
consider first for a moment exactly how
we might think about the security of our
phones representative of just any
Computing device and in fact everything
we discussed today could be extrapolated
to laptops and desktops and servers but
all of us being so familiar with phones
let's start with phones themselves now
odds are you have on your phone like so
many other things in your life a
password or a passcode and in fact
without raising your hands and therefore
leaking information think to yourself
well what is my my password or passcode
it's probably four digits it's maybe
four letters maybe it's even longer
maybe it's even nothing and I think
maybe from the chart earlier we can
assume that we have a third of each of
those possible responses so a password
of course is the super common mechanism
that you and I are all using all the
time to keep our devices secure but do
passwords keep things secure like how
many of you thinking about your phone
right now and that specific password
might think it's secure and if so
why do you think it's secure
we have at least 33 percent of you are
ready to say that your password secure
don't want to know it but why might it
be in your mind secure
why might you think it's secure or more
generally what makes your password
secure
it's random okay so it's random so
random letters and numbers and the like
and that's great because it's not just a
word in the dictionary that someone
could guess and type in downside of
course I dare say is that it might take
you as well as anyone else quite a bit
of time to guess or figure out what or
just to remember what it is if it was
indeed random but Randomness is going to
be a primitive that really actually
helps us unfortunately you and I and
really the whole world are not very good
even at passwords as omnipresent as they
are as a defense against adversaries in
fact if we look at um if we look at the
most common passwords from the past year
in 2020 thought we'd share with you some
of those results this is the result of
security researchers having found uh big
exploited compromised databases
analyzing them for what passwords are in
them and then inferring from that what
the most common passwords you and I are
all using unfortunately in 2020 the most
common password according to one measure
was one two three four five six
how funny yes but if you're seeing your
password on the screen already not so
funny perhaps
the number two password was not much
better
number three picture one presumably for
a device a website that requires that it
not just be a word to have at least one
number which this person took these
hundreds of thousands of people took
literally password was number four
this past year one two three four five
six seven eight one one one one one one
one really not trying hard there one two
three one two three varying it a little
bit one two three four five was number
eight one two three four five six seven
eight nine zero was number nine and then
number ten in 2020 was senya which any
Portuguese speakers here means
password means password so made the list
twice in this case so one takeaway
already today should be if your
password's on this list like probably
you're in one of those other 33 whereby
we can do better than this why I mean
really the obvious if you're in this
list there's so many bad guys so to
speak out there that are going to try
guessing your password first why because
just statistically if they try one two
three four five six one two three four
five six seven eight nine they're just
gonna get into a lot of devices quickly
because they're just so commonly used
those passwords you don't want to be on
this list ideally you want to be random
but we want to somehow balance
Randomness with memorability so that you
don't actually keep forgetting your
password which of course defeats the
whole point of these things in the first
place but in a class like this cs50 and
computer science more generally let's be
a little more thoughtful as to what we
mean by a device being secure like what
does it mean to be secure and can we
even slap some numbers on it so that we
can make measurements so that we can
ideally compare and contrast one one
system versus another one password
versus another so it's not just our
instincts arguing that my password is
better than these but how can you
quantify that perhaps well let's start
simply a lot of Android phones and
iPhones these days require minimally
that you have like a four digit passcode
you're minimally encouraged to have at
least this bar set so that you're not
having no passcode altogether so if you
do have a four digit passcode well let
me go ahead and ask this question how
much time might it take to go about
cracking so to speak that is figuring
out what a four digit passcode is in
fact let me go ahead if you want to pull
up your devices again you should see on
the screen this question now how am I
how long might it take to crack that is
figure out guess a four digit passcode
for instance on someone's phone a few
seconds a few minutes a few hours a few
days thinking here from the adversarial
perspective if someone got a hold of
your phone somehow
how long do they need to get into your
phone if it has a four
digit passcode a few seconds few minutes
a few hours few days got about 300
responses so far
let's give folks another few seconds
here
another few seconds here all right up to
350 or so in a moment let me go ahead
and flip screens over to the results so
we'll see the preliminary results here
and if I now pull this screen up we see
that 50 percent of you claim that it's
going to take only a few seconds a few
of you say about a third a few fewer of
you are saying that it takes a few
minutes a few hours and even a few days
well let's answer that first because
honestly if it's already a few days or
even longer our work is here probably
already pretty done unfortunately the
problem with things like four digit
passcodes is that anyone who grabs your
phone you step out of the room you leave
it behind you lose it they could
certainly mimic your input device and
just use their finger pretending to be
you trying zero zero zero zero nope zero
zero zero one nope zero zero zero two
nope and it's a little slow to be fair
it would take me a while to count all
the way up to
9999 that's ten thousand total
possibilities there but let's go ahead
and consider exactly how else you could
do it for instance here uh it's an
example of in computer science what we
call a Brute Force attack and just an
adversary using their finger is a Brute
Force attack if they're trying all
possible passcodes the problem is even
if your passcode is way at the end of
the list of numbers eventually they're
going to get it by brute force sort of
like in yesteryear using you know a
battering ram or the like to brute force
your way into a building a castle or the
like in software sense it just means
trying all possibilities and you don't
even have to just use your finger right
anyone with some programming Savvy who's
good with Hardware could maybe do
something like this here's a quick video
I'll hit play on no sound but a little
bit of a robot that has an Android phone
underneath it and it's got
a little robotic finger that's doing the
work for you you can step out of the
room now as the adversary let the robot
do its work trying zero zero zero zero
through nine nine nine nine and
ultimately presumably get into that
phone so let's see if we can't quantify
then exactly how fast the human or the
robot could get in well how many total
possibilities are there that's the right
way to begin thinking about it if you
have 10 digits for the first one zero
through nine and then another 10
possibilities another 10 another 10 the
total number of possibilities of course
between zero zero zero zero and nine
nine nine nine is ten thousand ten times
ten times ten times ten which gives us
that much of a search space a universe
of possible passcodes to choose among
unfortunately you can do even better
than your own finger or even that robot
anyone in cs50 now who knows a bit of
programming in languages called C or
python or anything else could open up a
programming window and actually just
start writing some code and so let me do
that what you're seeing here if a family
member is a programming environment
called Visual Studio code that students
have been using for the past several
weeks up here we have a tabbed window
where we can type our code down here we
have what's called a terminal window
where I can type command to make the
computer run that code and then over
here is just a menu bar so crack.pi
means I'm going to write a program to
crack that is figure out passwords using
this language called Python and you know
even though most cs50 students wouldn't
know what code to start writing they'd
have to look up some of what I'm about
to do it's only going to be a few lines
so I'm going to go up here and say from
string import digits this is a fancy way
of saying hey python give me access to
all decimal digits it just avoids my
having to type out zero through nine
manually alright then I'm going to say
from either tools import product this is
another feature of python that cs50
students for the most part have not yet
seen that just says Hey python give me
the ability to do like the cross product
of a whole bunch of numbers so these 10
times these 10 times these 10 times
these 10 and then what am I going to do
with that well for each possible
passcode in the product of those digits
repeated four times I'm going to go
ahead and for now let's just print out
what the passcode is in other words
assume that I am now the adversary I
don't want to waste time using my finger
I don't have a robot that I made but I
am good at writing software and heck
I've got like a USB or a lightning cable
in my bag that I could connect your
phone to my Mac or PC and I could just
have my code that I'm writing now send
all the possible codes from laptop to
phone to automate this process just
using the little port at the bottom of
all of our phones well let me go ahead
and maximize this so-called terminal
window which is again where I'm going to
run this code and again the question a
moment ago was does it take seconds
minutes hours days well let me go ahead
and run python of crack.pi I'm
pretending for the moment that I did
grab that cable for my bag and plug it
into the phone hitting enter and it
doesn't uh didn't actually do anything
that was not supposed to happen
so in cs50 we spend a lot of time
introducing students to bugs uh which
aren't mistakes in programs sometimes
not so deliberate let me go ahead and
apologize let me open this file
this didn't technically happen Okay
python or character there we go okay
in cs50 we now will run the code here
and I'm going to go ahead and run a
command called python of crack.pi I had
the file in the wrong location a moment
ago and this is the equivalent on a Mac
or PC of double clicking an icon here we
go is it seconds uh minutes hours or
days barely one second to try all 10 000
possibilities you can't even see them
all on the screen but this printed out
zero zero zero zero all the way down of
course to nine nine nine nine plug in
that cable and boom the adversary
doesn't need to be in that room for very
long in order to get into that that
phone all right so what would be better
then like clearly four digit passcodes
bad if you have someone in your life who
has a finger or a robot or the ability
to write code and unfortunately because
of us you now all have someone in the
family with at least a third of those
how might we do better than this
what's better than a four digit passcode
anyone
yeah
okay so six digits heck or seven digits
or eight digits why because that's going
to make the of course the passcode
longer which means we're gonna have to
try more possibilities which doesn't
mean that the adversary is fundamentally
stopped but it is going to slow them
down it's going to take them more time
probabilistically to get to your
passcode and in a sense then increases
the cost to the adversary and indeed
that's the theme in cyber security
raising the cost to the adversary either
financially or time wise or the like
just like in the real physical world
most of you go home you lock your doors
at night you might have invested in a
better deadbolt than another why is that
you really just want to be more secure
than the house next door you want to
make sure that it takes too much time
too much effort too much risk to the
adversary to get into your home and
that's again what cyber security is all
about to say my phone is secure it's
sort of nonsensical to say that your
phone is more secure than someone else's
that's really a reasonable Fair
statement to make so I like this
Instinct let's see if we can't make
things a little harder and actually
let's go one step further rather than
just numbers you've probably noticed on
your phones you can use letters of the
alphabet too if you click the right
option on the phone you can start typing
in words and letters so how might we do
that instead well let's transition to
four letter passcodes for letter pass
codes and if we do four letter pass
codes uh where the letters of the
alphabet for instance are a through z in
English alone let's go ahead and ask
this question here if you have four
letters of the alphabet so let's not
increase length yet let's just change to
a bigger vocabulary
now we have a through z instead of zero
through nine how many four letter
passcodes are possible how big is that
universe that the adversary is going to
have to search
via Brute Force so I'm seeing a lot of
seven Millions a bunch of fifty two
thousands twenty six thousands ten
thousands nine nine nine nine a few
smaller numbers here hopefully it's not
this low right because we've already set
the bar at ten thousand possibilities
for numbers alone hopefully if we've got
English letters a through z we can at
least do better than ten thousand so I
think we'll start to see maybe some of
these bars change a little bit but we've
got sixty percent of you proposing seven
million well let's go let's go to the
math so here we might have a way of
thinking about this both uppercase and
lowercase even better if you consider it
that way lowercase A through Z uppercase
A through Z that's 52 possibilities for
the first digit times 52 times 52 times
52 or 52 to the fourth power that indeed
gives you seven million plus
possibilities all right well let's now
translate this to code that already
sounds way better ten thousand versus
seven million this is definitely going
to slow that hacker down well let's
consider exactly how fast or slow it
might now be let me go into my crack.pi
program and let me make a little tweak
so that instead of just using digits
this time I'm going to use letters
otherwise known as ASCII letters that
cs50 students will know that just means
familiar English letters of the alphabet
and I'm going to change my code to use
these ASCII letters four of them still
instead of digits alone and that's the
only change now I'm going to pretend to
plug my phone that I just stole from
someone into a USB or a lightning cable
let me maximize my window just so we can
see things a bit more let me run python
of crack.pi now and let's consider how
long it takes to do 7 million possible
codes
okay slower
slower
can't dramatically just say in one
breath that we're done but we're already
at the G's and then the H is
and it's kind of flying by you know this
is where the adversary is probably
getting nervous in the TV show or movie
right someone is tiptoeing around in the
other room you don't want them to come
in you only have this much time to crack
the code
and we're at the RS the s is
T's use V so you know this feels like
what a minute or so it's a good number
of seconds but it's still pretty brief
certainly if someone has the ability to
now we got to do the capital letters too
certainly if someone has the ability not
to just secretly do it like in Hollywood
in the Next Room but just take it with
them and do it over the course of a
minute or two at home this seems to be
faster sorry this seems to be slower
because we're trying so many more
possibilities but you know if the
adversary takes your phone has it long
enough this doesn't feel like terribly
long so what might be better than this
let's take it one step further
what might be better than four letters
what what do most websites ask you to
add to the mix
so special characters right and those
things are darn annoying right because
sometimes they even tell you what
letters punctuation symbols you have to
use and then you type one and you're
like oh it's not on the damn list I mean
it's frustrating why well it's going to
raise the bar though to the adversary
and that's indeed going to be the goal
here again just to increase the cost or
time required for the adversary so that
it doesn't finish like it did just now
after a couple of minutes but it's going
to keep going and going hopefully such
that they're going to lose interest in
your phone and go try to crack into
someone else's presumably so let's try
this let me now go over to how about one
other question here and this question
will now just be let's go from four
characters how about let's take it one
step further and mix the two ideas here
more digits and longer passcodes how
many eight character passcodes are
possible and by character as a cs50
student will know I mean number or
letter or punctuation symbol now and
there's like 32 or so standard
punctuation symbols so we're up to a
good set of numbers now how many eight
character passcodes do you think are
possible million billion trillion
quadrillion or quintillion all of which
of course are better than 10 000
possibilities so we're in a whole
different space now
looks like these answers are coming in a
little more slowly perhaps as folks
think about this
this is 10 digits plus 52 letters plus
32 punctuation symbols
much more secure it would seem
all right we're up to 230 responses give
folks another second or so
if you're trying to do the math 10 plus
52 plus 32 that's going to give you 94
possibilities for each of the digits
all right we're just about at our
just about out our
350 all right I'm going to toggle over
the screen here going to click over to
the results show them in just a second
on the screen now and this is an
interesting distribution I think some of
you perhaps have the Instinct now just
go for the biggest one
um it's not quintillion nice as that
would be maybe it's quadrillion trillion
billion or million we have more of a
split there so let's consider the math
so if we've got eight characters and I
claim uh that that's 94 possibilities
for each 10 digits
52 letters 32 punctuation symbols that's
94 to the eighth power essentially and
that indeed is six quadrillion
possibilities now that's crazy big at
this point I dare say we're pretty safe
from the human finger now we're probably
pretty safe from that robot which is
going to take a while too but Max and
PCs are pretty darn fast and you know
God forbid the adversary have a big
server or use the cloud so to speak and
really use a big expensive machine how
long does it take to get into six
quadrillion possible passcodes well how
might we think about this suppose just
for the sake of discussion it takes the
adversary one second per code just so we
have some unit of measure to start with
one second per code which means in the
worst case the adversary rarely gets
screwed and my passcode is like nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine or with a
lot of crazy punctuation symbols in it
if each passcode takes a second to guess
how long is it going to take the
adversary if in the worst case they
spend six quadrillion seconds
how many hours or minutes
or days or
years I'm hearing a lot a lot is in fact
correct I did do the math the adversary
if they're lucky and get all this way
they're going to be 193
000 years old by the time they get to
all of those possible passcodes so this
sounds alluring and in fact let's just
change our code one final time just to
get a sense of how this might look and
behave in this version here let me go
back into my code
and let me change this now to use not
just ASCII letters but digits and I'm
going to add in punctuation for cs50
students there is again this Library
called the string library that gets lets
you just import all of these symbols
automatically so we don't have to type
out every character on my keyboard
manually and then down here I'm going to
take the product of those ASCII letters
again plus those digits plus the
punctuation repeated eight times I claim
this time I'm going to now increase the
size of my window just so we can see
more on the screen rerun the code and
this is going to take us you know some
hundreds of thousands of years so we
won't run to the end of this demo now we
seem to be in a better place all right
so what's the takeaway here clearly you
should use a passcode a password that's
eight characters with letters and
numbers and punctuation yes
okay you know there's a mix here some of
you are saying yes someone don't know
how about someone who says no why
why no yeah
recaptcha okay so there's other
mechanisms more on that in a second
other instincts yeah
yes I'm kind of cheating with my verbal
simplification here even this computer
is way faster than one code per second
so it's not going to be hundreds of
thousands of years might be tens of
thousands of years or hundreds of years
but it's it's not going to be quite as
dramatic as this so that's a concern
yes so maybe there's other mechanisms so
maybe we don't have to be so Extreme as
to introduce all of this Randomness as
was proposed before because honestly
there's this theme in computer science
too and really information technology of
trade-offs right sure I can come up with
I can use a really big random password
but my God I'm going to end up writing
it on my monitor on a Post-It note which
I suspect statistically some of you are
guilty of right and you shouldn't
necessarily just blame yourself or you
know your colleague who's doing this
like this is a symptom perhaps a bad I.T
policy if we don't have necessarily very
usable systems maybe we shouldn't blame
the human for forgetting their very
random password maybe we shouldn't
require the human to have a very random
password so what could we do a couple of
technical mechanisms were just proposed
let's go down this road of how we might
try to defend against this and I'll keep
this running just for fun in the
background let me switch back over to a
visual here now that we've considered
that many codes what if we do something
that some of your own phones already
have
that slow the adversary down and some of
you might have seen on your iPhone a
screen like this let me zoom in iPhone
is disabled try again in one minute has
anyone locked themselves out of their
phone like this I have this is not I
mean it's embarrassing to admit but it's
not leaking any information all right so
many of you have done that already but
why is this actually a compelling
feature just to be clear annoying as
this might be because you probably don't
want your phone locked at the very
moment you're trying to get into it why
might it be a good thing
yeah uh oh let's let's go somewhere else
if we may yeah I'm back
sorry
it slows down the process it annoys you
to be fair like you pay a bit of this
price but it really slows down the
adversary now they're going to be able
to type in not one code per second but
one code per minute a 60 times
difference that's really going to force
them to pump the brakes and unless that
adversary is after you specifically odds
are they're gonna go take someone else's
phone or lose interest because you've
raised the bar high enough to their
getting in on Android if you do this it
depends on the operating system version
here might be something similar on
Android too many attempts try again
later I mean this is even more annoying
it doesn't even tell you when to try
again later but it does slow down the
adversary so if you don't have features
like this enabled you should and if
you're particularly security conscious
or or paranoid even you can even enable
a feature on these phones nowadays where
they self-destruct so to speak after 10
wrong guesses right why 10 you know the
presumption is among Apple and Google
and others that if you type your
passcode 10 times wrong you're probably
not who you say you are you're probably
probably someone else although you know
if you're a little groggy first thing in
the morning or if you've been out late
and having a good time you tend might
not be a high enough threshold to sort
of protect your phone from you and so
there too is this trade-off again and
that's an extreme one if your phone
deletes itself as which is what I meant
by self-destruct then that might
actually be to your detriment unless you
have backups and all of that but that's
another technology question altogether
so there too this theme of trade-offs
you raise the bar to the adversary but
you've got to pay the price you're not
going to get any such feature for free
all right what's another mechanism that
many of us increasingly thankfully are
doing might be when you log into a
website like Gmail to have two Factor
authentication sometimes called two-step
authentication I mean how many of you
use two-factor two-step authentication
with at least one account all right so
that's amazing how many of you use it
with all of your accounts
all right fewer of us and there too
that's not necessarily the wrong answer
right I have a lot of stupid websites
that I have accounts on like I bought
something once on them I don't really
care about it so there's a judgment call
there in terms of what you really care
about but maybe your financial websites
your Healthcare websites or anything
that's mildly sensitive to you probably
should be raising the bar to the
adversary by enabling this so what is
this particularly for those of you who
didn't raise your hand someone else what
is two-factor or two-step authentication
what's two Factor yeah
yeah so when you have to pull out your
phone and verify that it's really you
we're in the corporate world you might
have a little dongle a key fob on your
keychain that's got a little number on
it but generally speaking two-factor
authentication is all about indeed a
second factor it's kind of
oversimplified as two steps but it's
really key technologically that it'd be
a different Factor it is not two-factor
authentication if you just have two
passwords that you have to remember
because both of those could be forgotten
by you both of those could be stolen by
someone else if you write them down the
Post-it note or the like two-factor
authentication is about having a
fundamentally different Factor available
to you so that the odds that someone get
at something you know like your password
and something you have like your phone
is just much much smaller than the
threat of just figuring out something
you know like a password alone so the
factor is something that's fundamentally
different from the other thing and so
once you configure this the user
typically sees a screen like this for
instance in the context of Gmail the
screens vary here at Harvard and Yale
students are familiar with something
called Duo Mobile which is the exact
same idea and they typically use
one-time code six digits thereabouts and
you can only use that code once and the
idea is it's texted to you or pushed to
your device so that you and only you can
use it
does this fundamentally secure your
account
is this enough to just have a good
password and two-factor Authentication
does that keep the adversaries out
altogether
not if someone what
okay not if someone really wants to get
in then you have other problems that are
are certainly of concern but you do want
to ideally keep most adversaries at Bay
and there too all we're doing is like
raising the bar right there's nothing
stopping someone in physical proximity
to me stealing my phone and getting into
all of those accounts I just raised my
hand about but you at least protect
yourself against the billions of other
potential adversaries in the world that
are geographically not near us so at
least narrow the threat so that's a good
thing
but what else could we do because I feel
like it's not fair for us to say all
right everyone go home start using
better passwords longer more complicated
because again there's this trade-off we
don't want to send everyone home
essentially with a pad of Post-it notes
to then counterbalance what's an
unrealistic expectation so how many of
you perhaps with a show of physical
hands use a password manager already
this is something practical we can equip
you with okay so that was relatively few
hands and those of you who are in The
Habit still of memorizing your password
or Worse writing down the password there
are better Solutions today but here too
there's going to be a caveat there's no
clear win necessarily a password manager
is a piece of software that you install
on your Mac or PC or your phone that
manages your passwords for you and these
come either built into the operating
system Mac Windows has credential
manager Mac OS is something called
keychain there's third-party software
like one password or LastPass companies
and universities often have site
licenses so that students in particular
can use these kinds of things for free
but the ones that come with your
operating system or phone are themselves
already free and not using them is
really the missed opportunity here so
what is a password manager it's a
program that yes manages your passwords
but it does a few things more it
generates passwords for you typically I
mean honestly it's been years since I
have chosen my own password on a website
I instead click a button in my password
manager software or I use a keyboard
shortcut to generate something that's
eight characters heck maybe 16 24 32
characters long I don't care because the
software's job is to manage that
password for me that is the software
remembers this crazy long password for
me and better yet it comes with a button
or a keyboard shortcut that will
automatically fill out forms for me on
the web when I say log me in it will
grab my password from my computer plug
it in and voila I'm logged in the upside
of this is that even if that website is
compromised and my password leaks out
I'm not using that password presumably
anywhere else because this job
software's job is generally to create
unique passwords for each website and
it's not going to be guessed via Brute
Force by one of you writing code because
it's just too long probabilistically you
know we're all going to be gone by the
time your computer finishes trying to
crack it
so what's the downside I mean this
sounds great if the software generates
passcodes for you and plugs them in for
you where's the downside
anyone yeah
yeah if you use someone else's computer
or you're in like a you know a library
environment a lab environment you don't
have your passwords accessible now
there's a way to mitigate that so long
as you sync the same software to your
phone you might have to pay another
dollar ninety nine or twenty dollars to
have the same software on your phone you
can at least mitigate that by sharing
the passcodes across your devices not as
user friendly you're still gonna have to
now manually type out this really long
password and that too is annoying if you
get one character wrong but that's one
way to mitigate that other concerns
that's maybe the biggest threats I mean
you're kind of putting all of your
proverbial eggs in the same basket if
someone now gets into my password
manager which I should stipulate is
supposed to itself have a really big
long password that I do have to remember
but only one such long password I mean
then I'm really out of luck now every
single account I own is compromised
except for except for those that at
least have two Factor unless the
adversary also steals my phone or my key
fob other concerns
exactly if someone gets physical access
to your device honestly in general all
bets are off and this is why some of
today's lessons are really important
it's only going to matter when you first
lose your phone or someone walks off
with your laptop or they're like there
are certain things you can do to defend
against that inevitability dare say but
you want to make sure that if you are
using some of these Solutions like a
password manager that that long primary
password you use for is itself really
hard to guess and you know I would say
I'm okay with you writing that down even
but putting it in like a safe deposit
box or hiding it somewhere in the house
that's just very low probability of
someone finding because the other
problem with putting all of your eggs in
one basket if you forget your password
then you lose everything and that too
seems like a pretty serious price to pay
but this is a constant battle in
Computing nowadays usability and
security and finding that inflection
point but there to You Can Be You Can Be
selective right I called out financial
information health and information your
personal email your calendar anything
that's mildly more sensitive to you or
important raise the bar at least on
those accounts even if you're not quite
ready to go all in on all of these these
other factors well let's consider then
where we're using these passwords
consider just a couple of specific
examples email of course Gmail is the
example I used earlier Gmail and email
accounts more generally are increasingly
offering us features and in fact there's
one that I thought we could highlight as
an example of something that as a cs50
students a cs50 family member you should
really start viewing the eye a little
more the the world with a more skeptical
eye a little more paranoid eye and not
necessarily just believe things that
websites say I mean it's mostly
meaningless when a website says
sometimes with a pretty little logo or
emblem our website is secure like what
does that even mean and it's again all
about relativity and even Gmail I dare
say somewhat irresponsibly has this
feature in recent years confidential
mode like is anyone if you're using G
Suite or Google apps at work or
workspace now days in the habit of using
confidential mode
I mean it sounds okay no one's using
this so this is great and I worry now
that I'm introducing you to a feature
that you shouldn't necessarily use but
all this time if you're a Gmail user
there is along the little menu bar an
icon that lets you enable confidential
mode and later tonight play around for
it just look for it and you'll see
exactly the screenshot which I took
yesterday according to google recipients
won't have the option to forward copy
print or download this email right great
for lawyers it would seem great for
business great for private
correspondence
but why is this perhaps a bit misleading
what's the
where should the skepticism come from
here even a company like Google I dare
say you know they've probably buried the
caveats that I'm hinting at under the
learn more but unfortunately that might
be too late yeah and back
yeah I mean those of you know how to
take a screenshot that's the simplest
way if you don't know how to do that
well here's a phone I can just take a
picture of what it is I see on the
screen and so these are software
defenses that are in place that
essentially disable the forward button
disable the print button but honestly as
you probably already know once something
is already digital I mean it's out there
and there are other ways to get it it
might not be as high quality if you're
taking out your phone to do it but you
should view things like this with
skepticism and even I when I
occasionally receive something like this
I kind of roll my eyes but regret that
the user thinks what they're doing is
consistent with this language but it
isn't necessarily and so indeed in part
from an introduction to computer science
you begin to I mean get a little scared
from what's going on out there because
there's so many different threats and so
many things that you can't in fact do
and the onus is unfortunately often on
us users to read between the lines and
see what actually is possible here's
another one that you might be more in
the habit of using incognito mode or
private mode and Chrome or Safari or
Firefox or Edge or or the like what does
incognito mode do if familiar
what's incognito mode yeah
it doesn't log locally what you're doing
exactly most people here probably
generally know about things called
cookies even if you're not quite sure
how they work but they're like these
little remnants or breadcrumbs you leave
behind when visiting websites that allow
the websites to keep track of where who
you are in some sense according to
google here when you're using incognito
mode Chrome won't save your browsing
history so that's good cookies and site
data information entered into forms but
to their credit they do disclaim that
your activity might still be visible to
the website to visit your employer or
School your internet service provider so
they're getting better at at least
helping you evaluate by giving more of
the facts whether you do or don't want
to do this but this doesn't mean that
the websites you're visiting indeed know
um don't know who you are all of our
computers have unique addresses these
things called IP addresses that you
might have heard about and cs50 will
explore these in another week's time
your computer is constantly leaking
information that could be used to infer
who you were so this is really just best
left when you don't want to accidentally
unlike a friend's computer or a lab
computer remain logged in because
cookies are typically used to just
remember that you've logged in so if you
use a friend's computer you use
incognito mode and just close the window
boom you're effectively logged out but
even as Google disclaims there's other
caveats there there too
so what else might we keep in mind how
about let's consider one other big one
that's another thing to start looking
for increasingly in order to keep
yourself secure and this one's a little
more technical encryption and that cs50
students will know this is something you
can Implement in code and in fact let me
ask this question what does it mean to
encrypt
something
think back to pset 2 and Caesar and the
like let me look a little farther back
almost any student hand should
theoretically be up here yeah
exactly encryption is all about
substituting one letter for another and
generally scrambling the appearance of
some message up so that the recipient
knows how to reverse that process and
see what you actually sent but anyone
intervening in between you can't
actually see the information between you
so just to impress uh the parents in the
rooms any students what does this say
we're not ending here but
this was cs50 that's what it would save
and notice the scramble let me go back
and forth back and forth uh in this
message T becomes you
H becomes I
becomes j s becomes T this is what we
called a few weeks ago in cs50 a
rotational site for a Caesar Cipher that
literally does this you describe
substitutes one letter for the next but
it does so in a very predictable way a
becomes b b becomes C and so forth and
we also talked weeks ago that you don't
have to keep it that simplistic you can
use a bigger mathematical formula to
make it at least harder for some
adversary to figure out but you and I as
users these days are constantly
thankfully using encryption you probably
generally know that you should be hoping
for expecting this these days like https
is a good thing s means secure literally
and any website that has that in its URL
indicates to you that you and the
website are having an encrypted a
scrambled communication which means if
you type in your password your credit
card information anything else
personally no one between you
theoretically points A and B should be
able to know what it is you've typed
into that web page the web page
absolutely can because they have the
process the ability to decrypt that
information to reverse the process but
at least encryption is generally a good
thing but today let's take that one step
further and encourage you all to be
looking for expecting if you will as
consumers increasingly in the coming
years something better than encryption
alone but end to end encryption and
you're starting to hear about read about
this a little bit more but it's perhaps
a little less familiar someone in the
room who's familiar what is end to end
encryption
let me give folks a moment what is end
to end
encryption
good so it's when an app like WhatsApp
encrypts a message but it's encrypted
all the way to the other side to the
recipient even though Facebook in this
case owns WhatsApp even though your
message is going through Facebook or
meta servers they do not have
theoretically the ability to decrypt
your message whatever chat message
you've sent to a friend they are just
sending seemingly random zeros and ones
all the way to the end user who can then
decrypt it if you're an iPhone user
iMessage for instance does this
automatically so long as your text
messages are blue and not green that
means you're using iMessage and Apple's
platform that does this but let's let's
focus perhaps on something that's been
all too familiar to most of us over this
past year Zoom right Zoom actually took
some Flack some months ago because in
their marketing literature they were
advertising end-to-end encryption they
were not implementing end-to-end
encryption at least initially this was
probably marketing gone awry not quite
understanding what end to end option
means they were using encryption and
what that meant is that if I were having
a meeting with a colleague or you were
sitting in on a class with a teacher you
might have an encrypted connection all
of you choose Zoom centrally but they
had the ability early on and still now
if you leave this feature off to decrypt
that information and see and listen to
theoretically anything going on in that
meeting or that classroom now
technologically there's not really a
good defense against that if using that
older approach all it really is is
policy or hopefully there's rules in
place there's contracts in place that
say well yeah that's possible but don't
do that end-to-end encryption is a
stronger guarantee for you that
circumvents that risk altogether by
ensuring that if you're tuning into that
class or you're logging into that
meeting all of the zeros and ones are
going through Zoom servers just like
Facebooks but only the end users only
the students and teachers only the
colleague and colleague can actually
decrypt and see and hear what it is
that's being said and if you're one who
schedules Zoom meetings you can actually
see this for instance here's a
screenshot I took yesterday too
scheduling like a zoom meeting for today
and you'll see that you can choose the
Day and The Time the password haha and
also down here the encryption level and
by default it's typically enhanced
encryption which is stupid like enhanced
encryption it's just encryption and in
fact it's sort of worse encryption than
the other checkbox which is end-to-end
encryption but there's this little
caveat and here too consistent with this
reality in Computing there's always a
trade-off right it's not all upside and
all win several features will be
automatically disabled when using
end-to-end encryption including Cloud
recording and some phone stuff I mean
that's already kind of a big loss for a
class for instance a conference that
wants to keep the sessions but it kind
of makes sense right if the data is
encrypted between all of the end users
and therefore Zoom has no eyes into the
data or ears then it makes sense that
they can't record it for you in the
cloud because it's completely completely
scrambled to them too so a good
primitive to have in place but also
something that you need to sacrifice in
terms of usability well let me in our
final moments here let me flip back over
to where our hacking tool is it would
seem that eight characters is doing
really well because we still got three
A's at the beginning of this so that
might be in fact one takeaway and in
fact let me flip over and propose three
pieces of homework for everyone here one
use a password manager the one that's
built into your phone or your operating
system or pay a little something more
for something that you might like a
little better two use two-factor
authentication for more of your accounts
maybe not all but at least more of your
accounts and that's certainly a net
Improvement and then three use not just
encryption but end-to-end encryption and
unfortunately these features are not all
quite as simple as oh well let me just
check the box and turn on that
something's something that's always been
available to me because it's not always
been available and zoom only once they
sort of got in trouble for this do they
acquire some other company that
implements this feature and then add it
to their song software but as users as
consumers as parents as students
considering choosing one tool or another
because of these features is really
something you are empowered to do and do
not use those tools that you don't think
meet some threshold of comfort for you
for more on this and computer science
more generally any of you can take cs50
online at edx.org cs50 it's been so nice
to see you happy to chat one-on-one but
otherwise have a wonderful day here on
campus this was cs50
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]